ALL RIGHT. SENATE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY WILL COME TO ORDER.
MORNING. WE'RE HOLDING THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING IN ROOM 112 OF
THE STATE CAPITOL. I ASK THAT
ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BE
PRESENT IN ROOM 112. SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND BEGIN OUR
HEARING. THE VICE CHAIR IS HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. VICE
CHAIR, BEFORE WE BEGIN
PRESENTATION OF TODAY'S BILLS,
I'M GOING TO. WELL, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO A QUORUM QUITE YET,
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO IS WE'RE
GOING TO ANNOUNCE THAT WE ONLY
HAVE 50. WE ONLY HAVE 68 BILLS
ON OUR AGENDA TODAY. I'M SORRY.
I'M CORRECTED. 60. THEY'RE
DROPPING FAST. 65 BILLS ON OUR
AGENDA TODAY, WE'LL BE IN STATE
CAPITAL ROOM 112 ALL DAY TODAY,
IT WAS PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED THAT
WE WOULD BE IN ROOM 113. WE'RE
NOT. WE'RE IN 112, AND WE'LL BE
HERE ALL DAY, WE WILL NOT BE
BREAKING FOR LUNCH OR MOVING
ROOMS, SO ONCE AGAIN, WE'LL BE
HERE IN ROOM 112. I WANT TO
THANK THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE WORK THAT THEY'VE
BEEN DOING. YES. YOU MAY NOTE
RIGHT. THEY'VE BEEN GOING ON
VERY LITTLE SLEEP OVER THE LAST
PROBABLY MONTH, THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING NONSTOP THESE PAST FIVE
WEEKS ANALYZING OVER 200
ASSEMBLY BILLS, WHICH IS ABOUT
50 MORE ASSEMBLY BILLS THAN
NORMALLY ARE REFERRED TO THIS
COMMITTEE. WE'RE PROUD TO BE SO
POPULAR, AND A SPECIAL THANK YOU
TO OUR ASSISTANTS, MARGARET
BUXTON AND ERICA PORTER, FOR ALL
THE WORK THEY'VE DONE OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST YEAR, BUT IN
PARTICULAR THE LAST MONTH. AND
COUNSEL IAN DOHERTY, ALISON
MEREDITH, AMANDA MADSEN AND OUR
DEPUTY CHIEF COUNSEL, CHRISTIAN
KARPINSKI, AND OF COURSE, MARGIE
ESTRADA, CHIEF COUNSEL. I'M
LUCKY AND GRATEFUL TO HAVE THEM
ON OUR STAFF. IN FACT, THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS LUCKY AND
GRATEFUL TO HAVE THEM. EMPLOYEES
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE STATE SENATE. LET ME GO
THROUGH SOME HOUSEKEEPING
MEASURES, FILE NUMBER SEVEN, AB
1333 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD HAS
BEEN PULLED. FILE NUMBER EIGHT,
AB 491 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALLACE HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
NUMBER NINE AB 1780 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING HAS BEEN PULLED.
FILE NUMBER 32, FILE EN. EXCUSE
ME. FILE ON NUMBER 32 AB 2584 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. LEE HAS BEEN
PULLED. FILE NUMBER 48 AB 2862
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON HAS
BEEN PULLED. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
TURN TO THE BILLS THAT ARE ON
TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR. WE
HAVE 12 AND THEY ARE AS FOLLOWS.
FILE NUMBER 12 AB 2424 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCHIAVO, FILE
NUMBER 22 BY AB, AB 2992 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEPHANIE
NGUYEN. FILE NUMBER 30 AB 2148
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW FILE
NUMBER 36, AB 2926 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. FILE NUMBER 38, AB
3280 BY ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. FILE NUMBER 41 AB
1876 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON,
FILE NUMBER 45 AB 1934 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON, FILE
NUMBER 46 AB 2062 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON, WITH AMENDMENTS
FILED NUMBER 49, AB 1878 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. 52 AB
1862 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN,
WITH AMENDMENTS FILED. NUMBER 55
AB 2664 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRYANT WITH AMENDMENTS, AND
FINALLY FILE NUMBER 69, AB 2606
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY,
ALL RIGHT. SO WE'RE GOING TO
FIRST PROCEED AS A SUBCOMMITTEE,
HERE ARE THE RULES FOR TODAY.
THEY'RE THE SAME AS EVERY OTHER
COMMITTEE HEARING THAT THE
SUPPORT SIDE MAY HAVE TWO
WITNESSES, EACH WITH TWO MINUTES
EACH. SO FOR A TOTAL OF FOUR
MINUTES FOR PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT, FOLLOWED BY WITNESSES
WHO MAY APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AND PROVIDE US THEIR NAME, THEIR
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL, THEN WE'LL TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION. THE SAME WILL GO
FOR THE OPPOSITION. EACH SIDE,
EACH PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION, WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES FOR A TOTAL OF FOUR
MINUTES IN OPPOSITION. AND THEN
WE'LL TURN TO OPPOSITION. ME,
TWO WITNESSES WHO WILL PROVIDE
THEIR NAME, THEIR AFFILIATION
AND THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL.
NOW, TODAY, AS YOU HEARD, QUITE
A NUMBER OF TIMES, WE'RE GOING
IN REVERSE ORDER, MEANING THAT
THE FIRST SHALL BE LAST, AND THE
LAST SHALL BE FIRST. SO LET US
START, WITH MR. ZUBIATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S A BR. WELCOME.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. MR. RIGHT
TABLE. GO AHEAD. YES. RIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS, I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE ORDER OF THE AGENDA TODAY
AND I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB 2889,
A MEASURE THAT MAKES RESOLVING
LABOR DISPUTES MORE EFFICIENT,
EFFECTIVE AND FAIR WITHIN THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES. THE BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS, SEIU CALIFORNIA AND AC
CALIFORNIA. THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS BOARD, OR PERB,
CURRENTLY HAS OVERSIGHT
JURISDICTION OVER DISPUTES
BETWEEN ALMOST ALL PUBLIC AGENCY
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES. HOWEVER
CURRENT LAW PROVIDES THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES WITH A
LOCAL ALTERNATIVE TO PERB
OVERSIGHT. THE LOS ANGELES LOCAL
ALTERNATIVE HAS THE POWER TO
INVESTIGATE UNFAIR PRACTICE
CHARGES, DETERMINE WHETHER THOSE
CHARGES ARE JUSTIFIED, AND, IF
SO, PRESCRIBE APPROPRIATE
REMEDIES. THE STANDARD THAT
APPLIES TO THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES GIVES EMPLOYERS
AN UNFAIR LEVERAGE THAT IS NOT
PRESENT IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE. THIS MEANS THAT UNIONS
THAT BARGAIN WITH THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES ARE THE
ONLY PUBLIC EMPLOYEE UNIONS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
NOT AFFORDED THE SAME EXTENT OF
PROTECTIONS THAT OTHER PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE UNIONS OBTAIN FROM PERB
A BIT OF HISTORY IN 2011, THE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED PROTECTIONS
TO PROHIBIT UNION BUSTING WITHIN
THE JURISDICTION OF PERB THAT
YEAR, SB 857 PROHIBITED PERB
FROM AWARDING STRIKE PREPARATION
EXPENSES AS DAMAGES FROM AN
UNLAWFUL STRIKE DUE TO A
DRAFTING ERROR. THE EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS ENTITIES IN THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES WERE
EXPRESSLY IDENTIFIED IN THE LAW,
WHICH MEANS THESE PROTECTIONS
WERE NOT EXPRESSLY IDENTIFIED IN
THE LAW, WHICH MEANS THAT THESE
PROTECTIONS MAY NOT APPLY TO
UNIONS UNDER THEIR JURISDICTION.
MANY OF THE ACTIVITIES WORKERS
ROUTINELY ENGAGE IN DURING A
CONTRACT CAMPAIGN, SUCH AS
MEMBERSHIP RALLIES, WEARING
UNION BUTTONS, OR PARTICIPATING
IN A STRIKE AUTHORIZATION VOTE,
COULD BE USED TO JUSTIFY THESE
DAMAGES. HOWEVER, I THINK WE CAN
ALL AGREE THE RIGHT TO
COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN IS NOT
MEANINGFUL IF WORKERS CANNOT
ENGAGE IN CONCERTED ACTIVITIES.
THIS BILL NOT ONLY IS ABOUT
ALIGNING LABOR PRACTICES ACROSS
THE STATE, IT'S ABOUT A FAIRNESS
FOR ALL PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYEES
IN CALIFORNIA. SO AB 2889
PROVIDES PERB WITH EXCLUSIVE
INITIAL JURISDICTION OVER
REQUESTS FOR INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
BY BOTH THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES. JUST AS IT ALREADY
HAS FOR OTHER PUBLIC AGENCIES.
IT ALSO CLARIFIES THAT LOCAL
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS ENTITIES IN
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES DO NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO AWARD DAMAGES
RESULTING FROM A STRIKE BECAUSE,
OF COURSE, THIS HAS BEEN
TRANSFERRED TO PERB. THIS
ENSURES THAT LOCAL PUBLIC SECTOR
UNIONS AND THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES HAVE THE SAME THE
VERY SAME PROTECTION FROM UNION
BUSTING TACTICS THAT ALL OTHER
UNIONS UNDER PERB JURISDICTION
HAVE ENJOYED FOR OVER A DECADE.
THIS BILL HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION. I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND
WITH ME TODAY ARE SANDRA BORRERO
REPRESENTING. ACTUALLY WE IS
JANICE O'MALLEY REPRESENTING ASM
CALIFORNIA AND GEORGE OSBORNE
REPRESENTING UAPD. ARNIE. THANK
YOU. LET'S START WITH MISS
O'MALLEY. YES, SIR, GOOD
MORNING, JANICE O'MALLEY,
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH AFSCME
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE ALSO
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL, AS THE
CO-SPONSORS THAT YOU HAVE GONE
IN REVERSE ORDER, AFSCME WAS THE
ORIGINAL SPONSOR OF SB 857 13
YEARS AGO WHEN IT WAS AUTHORED
BY THEN SENATOR, NOW CONGRESSMAN
TED LIEU, TO PROTECT EVERY
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE IN CALIFORNIA
FROM ATTACKS ON THE RIGHT TO
STRIKE AND SAVING WORKERS
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FALSE AND
FRIVOLOUS CLAIMS. THE LAW WAS
CREATED TO PROTECT ALL UNIONS
FROM UNION BUSTING TACTICS AS A
RIGHT TO COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN IS
IMPAIRED WHEN WORKERS ARE
DISSUADED UNDER THREAT OF
EXORBITANT DAMAGES FROM ENGAGING
IN CONCERTED ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
WEARING BUTTONS OR ATTENDING A
RALLY, THE PREMISE THAT AN
EMPLOYER IS ENTITLED TO STRIKE
PREPARATION DAMAGES, INCLUDING
WHERE NO STRIKE EVEN OCCURRED
DIRECTLY INTERFERES WITH THE
ABILITY OF WORKERS TO EXERCISE
THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE LAW. WHEN
AFSCME SPONSORED SB 857, IN
2011, THE ASSUMPTION WAS THAT IT
WOULD COVER ALL PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
AND THOSE UNDER THE MYERS BROWN
ACT, THE ACT THAT ESTABLISHES
BARGAINING FOR CALIFORNIA'S
MUNICIPAL, COUNTY, AND LOCAL
SPECIAL DISTRICT EMPLOYEES, BUT
THIS BILL WAS PASSED IN 2011
BEFORE A COURT OF APPEAL
DECISION ESTABLISHED PERB IN THE
MBA, BUT FAILED TO EXPRESSLY
IDENTIFY, LÀ HERB AND LÀ, OR
C¢M, AND THEREFORE IT IS LEGALLY
LEFT UNCLEAR WHETHER BOTH THESE
ENTITIES ARE EMPLOYEES IN THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF LÀ HAVE THE
RIGHTS AS THEIR UNION, THE SAME
RIGHTS AS THEIR UNION SIBLINGS
IN OTHER MEMBER JURISDICTIONS,
THEREFORE, WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB 2889 TO AFFORD
THE SAME STRIKE PROTECTION
RIGHTS TO LA CITY AND LA COUNTY
EMPLOYEES AS ALL OTHER PUBLIC
SECTOR EMPLOYEES CURRENTLY
ENJOY. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. GO
AHEAD SIR. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. GEORGE OSBORNE, FOR THE
UNION OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTIST. I JUST WANTED TO
REITERATE THAT THIS IS A CLEANUP
BILL AGAIN FOR SB 857. BY THEN
SENATOR LOU LÀ CITY LÀ COUNTY
ARE THE ONLY TWO JURISDICTIONS
THAT WERE LEFT OUT IN THE STATE
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. OTHERS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. SANDRA
BORRERO, ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA. PROUD CO-SPONSORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS
SARA FLOCKS, CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. OTHER
THAN SUPPORT, SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE, LET'S
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 2889,
PLEASE COME FORWARD SEEING NO
ONE COMING FORWARD, LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. QUESTIONS? COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE. ALL RIGHT. WE'D
LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
OF B¢O. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. AT SUCH TIME, I EXPECT
THERE'LL BE A MOTION AND WE'LL
BRING IT TO A VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT, NEXT, WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD, AND I SEE
THAT WE'RE BLESSED WITH QUITE A
NUMBER OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HERE
RIGHT NOW. SO IF WE WENT IN
NORMAL ORDER, WE WOULD GO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD, WHO'S AT
THE TABLE, THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILSON, THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS, THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING. SO. AND IF JUST FOR FUTURE
. OH YES. YES. YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU'RE RIGHT. WE NEED TO SWITCH
THE ORDER UP A LITTLE BIT. YES.
I SEE ON MY PLAYBOOK HERE. WE
GOT IT. WE'LL SWITCH THE ORDER.
YES. SO REMEMBER TO VENTING. ALL
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. SO MEMBER WOOD
FLOOR IS YOURS. I'D JUST LIKE TO
COMMENT THAT IT'S YOU ACTUALLY
HAVE MORE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HERE
THAN WHEN WE GAVEL DOWN TO START
ASSEMBLY FLOOR SESSIONS. SO THAT
THAT'S A PRETTY AMAZING SENATOR
UMBERG. AND YOU'RE ONE SHY OF A
QUORUM, WHICH IS ALSO PRETTY
AMAZING THIS EARLY IN THE
MORNING. SO MY HAT'S OFF TO THE
SENATE. OUR ONE SHY. WE THANK
YOU FOR NOTING THAT WE ARE ONE
SHY OF A QUORUM. ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT. GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR FOR ENGAGING
WITH ME ON EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
THE CHALLENGES OF PRIVATE EQUITY
AND HEALTH CARE. AND THANK YOU
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
SEVERAL OF YOU I KNOW I'VE
SPOKEN TO PERSONALLY SEVERAL
TIMES. AFTER MUCH THOUGHT, I
HAVE COMMITTED TO THE CHAIR THAT
I WILL DRAFT AUTHOR AMENDMENTS
TO REMOVE FOR PROFIT ACUTE CARE
HOSPITALS FROM THE BILL. IF THE
BILL PASSES TODAY, THOSE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE READY BEFORE
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE FOR
PROFIT, FOR PROFIT TRANSACTION.
HOSPITAL TRANSACTIONS MUST STILL
NOTIFY OHCA AS ORIGINALLY
REQUIRED IN THE IN THE BILL. I
DO THIS WITH A GREAT DEAL OF
DISAPPOINTMENT. THIS BILL IS A
PRODUCT OF MANY HOURS OF
DISCUSSIONS WITH COMMITTEE
CHAIRS AND STAKEHOLDERS. AND
ALTHOUGH A NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDERS WILL NOT BE HAPPY
WITH WHAT I HAVE DESCRIBED, NO
ONE WILL BE LESS HAPPY THAN ME.
I BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT WE
SHOULD MAKE PROGRESS WHERE AND
WHEN WE CAN. ONCE THIS PROCESS
IS IN PLACE. IF THE BILL PASSES
AND SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR, I'M
CONFIDENT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILL SHOW THAT THE REVIEW OF
THESE TRANSACTIONS WILL NOT BE
ONEROUS AND WILL PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS FROM INCREASED
COSTS AND LACK OF ACCESS. AB
3129 HAS ALWAYS BEEN ABOUT
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITIES, OUR
PATIENTS AND ALL HEALTH CARE
CONSUMERS FROM FROM THE
POTENTIALLY NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF
PRIVATE EQUITY TRANSACTION,
PRIVATE EQUITY TRANSACTIONS IN
HEALTH CARE, PRIVATE EQUITY
INVESTMENT IN HEALTH CARE HAS
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE
PAST TWO DECADES. TRANSACTIONS
IN HEALTH CARE IN 2021 TOTALED
$83 BILLION $20 BILLION OF THAT
IN CALIFORNIA COMPARED TO $12
BILLION AND 1 BILLION
RESPECTIVELY, IN 2005. THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE THAT
PRIVATE EQUITY INVESTMENT ACROSS
ALL OUTCOME MEASURES HAS MOST
OFTEN INCREASED COSTS TO
PATIENTS OR PAYERS, AND HAD
MIXED TO HARMFUL IMPACTS ON
QUALITY PRIVATE EQUITY'S
TIMELINES ARE SHORT, OFTEN 3 TO
7 YEARS, AND HAVE OCCURRED
ACROSS THE BOARD IN MANY AREAS.
THE TRANSACTION OFTEN USED 60 TO
80% DEBT, WHICH THEN BECOMES A
BURDEN ON THE ENTITY. WE HAVE
MANY EXAMPLES THAT SHOW PRIVATE
EQUITY FIRMS USE THAT DEBT TO
PAY DIVIDENDS TO THEMSELVES AND
THEIR INVESTORS, WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME LEAVING THOSE ACQUIRED
ON THE HOOK FOR THAT DEBT. THAT
HAS RESULTED IN A NUMBER OF
BANKRUPTCIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME LEAVING
INVESTORS WITH HIGH REWARDS
INSTEAD OF LOSSES. I CONTINUE TO
BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE EFFECTS
OF CONSOLIDATION WHEN PRIVATE
EQUITY PURCHASES SEVERAL
PRACTICES IN AN AREA, ESPECIALLY
IN MORE RURAL AREAS, IT CAN
CREATE A MONOPOLY OR CLOSE TO IT
THAT USES ITS LEVERAGE TO
NEGOTIATE HIGHER, HIGHER FEES
WITH HEALTH PLANS. IN TURN,
INCREASING HEALTH CARE PREMIUMS
TO EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYERS AND
COSTS TO PATIENTS. THIS BILL
WILL NOT PREVENT THESE
TRANSACTIONS, BUT ALLOWS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO REVIEW THEM
AND ENSURE THAT TRANSACTIONS
DON'T RESULT IN LIMITED OR NO
CARE FOR CERTAIN POPULATIONS OR
ACCESS TO SPECIALTY OR OTHER
CARE. YOU KNOW ME, I HOPE I'M A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER, IS ALWAYS
FOUGHT FOR INCREASED ACCESS AND
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AND I'VE DUG INTO
THOSE ISSUES DEEPLY, WITH MUCH
THOUGHT AND COMMITMENT. WE NEED
OVERSIGHT NOW. WE CAN'T WAIT.
WHY? BECAUSE THERE IS NONE.
PRIVATE EQUITY IS ACTIVE IN MANY
ARENAS. THE DONUT SHOP WHERE YOU
MAY HAVE STOPPED AT ON YOUR WAY
TO WORK THIS MORNING, THE
NURSING HOME WHERE YOUR
GRANDMOTHER RESIDES, THE
APARTMENT OR SINGLE FAMILY HOME
YOU RENT, THE VETERINARY CLINIC
WHERE YOU TAKE FIDO AND FLUFFY.
THIS IS ALL HAPPENING AT AN
EXPONENTIAL RATE. THIS TREND IS
NO LONGER EMERGING. IT IS HERE
AND IT IS GROWING EVERY YEAR, SO
I'M OBLIGED TO DO WHAT I CAN TO
KEEP THIS ISSUE A PRIORITY. I'LL
GET TO WORK ON THE BILL TO
ADDRESS THE AMENDMENTS I'VE
SPOKEN ABOUT TODAY, AND
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY. I
HAVE WITH ME TO TESTIFY, DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL TIFFANY BROKAW
FROM THE AG'S OFFICE, JOINED BY
EMILIO VARANINI, WHO WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS, AND KATIE VAN DYNES,
THE POLICY AND LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FROM HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA, IS OUR SECOND
WITNESS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER, WOULD LET US
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. THAT EVER
ELUSIVE QUORUM. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR
PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING QUORUM.
UMBERG HERE. UMBERG HERE. WILK
PRESENT. WILK. PRESENT. ALLEN
ASHBY. CABALLERO. DURAZZO.
DURAZZO HERE. LAIRD. HERE.
LAIRD. HERE. NIELLO HERE.
NIELLO. HERE. ROTH. ROTH. HERE
STERN. WAHAB, YOU HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
WITNESSING THIS MOMENT. AT 8:18
A.M, THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE HAS A QUORUM. ALL
RIGHT, THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOOD, FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS BILL. I KNOW THAT YOU FEEL
QUITE PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS
SUBJECT, AND YOU'VE WORKED VERY,
VERY HARD. AND I KNOW THAT SOME
OF THESE AMENDMENTS ARE,
CHALLENGING. FOR YOU AND THE
FOLKS WHO SUPPORT, A COUPLE OF
THINGS JUST TO CLEAR IT UP. I
KNOW YOU MENTIONED ACUTE CARE
HOSPITALS, AND THAT'S A TERM OF
ART IN THE STATUTE, BUT IT'S ALL
FOR PROFIT HOSPITALS, CORRECT?
FOR ALL, FOR PROFIT HOSPITALS.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, OKAY,
LET'S TURN TO YOUR WITNESSES,
FIRST WITNESS, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
TIFFANY BROKAW, DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB
BONTA, WHO IS A PROUD SPONSOR OF
AB 3129. AND THANKS, DOCTOR WOOD
FOR HIS CONTINUED WORK TO
ADDRESS CONSOLIDATION IN
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE MARKET.
AB 3129 AUTHORIZES THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO REVIEW HEALTH CARE
TRANSACTIONS INVOLVING PRIVATE
EQUITY AND HEDGE FUND GROUPS,
AND REINFORCES THE EXISTING BAR
ON THE CORPORATE PRACTICE OF
MEDICINE AS IT APPLIES TO THE
INTERFERENCE OF PRIVATE EQUITY
GROUPS OR HEDGE FUNDS IN THE
MEDICAL CARE OF PATIENTS. AS
DOCTOR WOOD MENTIONED, WE PLAN
TO EXEMPT FOR PROFIT HOSPITALS
FROM THE BILL. SO THIS BILL
FOCUSES ON PRIVATE EQUITY
BECAUSE THE PRIVATE EQUITY
BUSINESS MODEL, WHICH IS
DESIGNED TO BUY AN ASSET,
MAXIMIZE PROFITS AND SELL THAT
ASSET, HAS CONCERNING EFFECTS
WHEN APPLIED TO OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM. AND THESE TRANSACTIONS
HAVE DOUBLED IN THE PAST DECADE.
SO IN THE HEALTH CARE CONTEXT,
WE ARE SEEING CUTS TO STAFF AND
SERVICES BEING MADE TO INCREASE
PROFITS. AND THEN WHEN THAT
ENTITY IS SOLD, THEY CAN BE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO BANKRUPTCY AND
FURTHER CONSOLIDATION,
JEOPARDIZING THE COMMUNITY'S
ACCESS TO CARE. AB 3129 WOULD
SET UP OVERSIGHT OVER THESE
TRANSACTIONS, WHERE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WOULD BE AUTHORIZED TO
APPROVE, DENY OR APPROVE WITH
CONDITIONS THESE TRANSACTIONS
BASED ON WHETHER THEY ARE IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST, THE CONDITIONS
THAT THE AG WOULD PLACE ON A
TRANSACTION ARE DESIGNED TO KEEP
THESE SERVICES OPEN AND
AFFORDABLE. SO, FOR EXAMPLE, A
CONDITION THAT THE AG USES IN
HIS CURRENT ROLE REVIEWING
NONPROFIT HOSPITAL TRANSACTIONS
AND THAT WOULD BE USED IN THIS
CONTEXT TO PRIVATE EQUITY
ACQUISITIONS, WOULD BE THAT
SERVICES NEED TO BE MAINTAINED.
SO, YES, THIS TRANSACTION CAN
HAPPEN, BUT THIS PROVIDER GROUP
OR LONG TERM CARE FACILITY WOULD
NEED TO CONTINUE SERVING
MEDI-CAL PATIENTS. A CONDITION
CAN ALSO COME IN THE FORM OF
PRICE INCREASE CAPS, SO THAT
PRICES FOR SERVICES DON'T
SKYROCKET AND BECOME
UNAFFORDABLE. THIS REVIEW
PROCESS IS NOT AN AUTOMATIC
DENIAL OF THESE TRANSACTIONS.
THE OVERSIGHT IS TO HELP ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE AND THAT
SERVICES REMAIN AVAILABLE TO
THOSE WHO NEED IT. FOR THESE
REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ALRIGHTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MISS BROKAW, OTHERS
IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR, AND SENATORS. I'M KATIE
VAN DINES WITH HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA, THE STATEWIDE
HEALTHCARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION, AND WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 3129 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOOD. FOR MORE THAN 30
YEARS, ATTORNEYS GENERAL OF BOTH
PARTIES HAVE HAD THE AUTHORITY
TO APPROVE, DENY OR APPROVE WITH
CONDITIONS MERGERS RELATED TO
NONPROFIT HEALTH FACILITIES AND
IN THESE LAST 30 YEARS, BETWEEN
80 AND 90% OF THOSE PROPOSED
MERGERS HAVE BEEN APPROVED,
MOSTLY WITH CONDITIONS TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS AND THESE
CONDITIONS HAVE BEEN TO KEEP
SERVICES OPEN AND MORE RECENTLY,
TO PREVENT PRICE HIKES AS A
RESULT OF MERGERS. EXACTLY THE
SORT OF CONDITIONS NEEDED TO
PROTECT ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE IN THE AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES. THIS PROCESS IS NOT
NEW. WHAT IS NEW IS THAT PRIVATE
EQUITY IS TAKING OVER HOSPITALS,
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
DOCTORS OFFICES, AND RECENT
RESEARCH IS SHOWING THAT THIS
CAN LEAD TO PRICE INCREASES,
DANGEROUS IMPACTS ON QUALITY AND
RISKS FOR ACCESS TO CARE AND
LOSS OF SERVICES. ONE STUDY
FOUND THAT PRIVATE EQUITY
ACQUISITIONS OF PHYSICIAN
PRACTICES LEADS TO PRICE
INCREASES, RANGING FROM 16% IN
ONCOLOGY TO 4% IN PRIMARY CARE
AND DERMATOLOGY, AND IN
COMMUNITIES WHERE PRIVATE EQUITY
DOMINATE PHYSICIAN SPECIALTIES
COMPARED TO OTHER US MARKETS.
PRICE INCREASES WERE UP TO THREE
TIMES HIGHER IN A NURSING HOMES.
PRIVATE EQUITY. EQUITY OWNERSHIP
WAS FOUND TO INCREASE DEATH
RATES OF PATIENTS WITH MEDICARE
COVERAGE BY 10% ÁP 3129, WITH
SUBJECT SPECIFIC PRIVATE EQUITY
TRANSACTIONS IN HEALTH CARE TO
THE SAME SORT OF SCRUTINY AND
OVERSIGHT THAT NONPROFIT HEALTH
FACILITIES HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO
FOR DECADES. AND WHILE THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY, OR OCA WILL BE
REVIEWING THESE ACQUISITIONS,
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO APPROVE, DENY OR APPROVE WITH
CONDITIONS THESE ACQUISITIONS TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS, WE NEED THE
AG TO HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO ACT
BEFORE AN ACQUISITION HAPPENS TO
PREVENT THE POTENTIAL HARM TO
COMMUNITIES AND PROTECT
AFFORDABLE CARE WHEN THERE IS A
MERGER OR ACQUISITION IN HEALTH
CARE, WE HEAR ABOUT THE
WONDERFUL THINGS THAT WILL
HAPPEN INNOVATION, EFFICIENCY
AND MORE. AND WE WANT THOSE
THINGS FOR OUR COMMUNITIES TOO.
BUT WE WANT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO ACT
NOW, TO HOLD PRIVATE EQUITY
ACCOUNTABLE TO THOSE PROMISES
AND PREVENT THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS
THAT WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT. AND
WITH THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS, WE
THINK THAT THIS WHILE WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL PRIOR, WE
STILL THINK THIS BILL WITH THE
ACQUISITIONS, ACQUISITIONS THAT
ARE INCLUDED ARE VERY IMPORTANT
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM THESE
PRIVATE EQUITY ACQUISITIONS AND
GIVE THE AUTHORITY NOW FOR THE
AG TO PROTECT CONSUMERS. THANK
YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE, YOUR NAME, YOUR
AFFILIATION, YOUR POSITION. MR.
CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, BRANDON MARKEY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION, REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS BUT IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. SANDRA BROUGH,
ON BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS TIM MADDEN,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. SYMPHONY BARBIE, ON
BEHALF OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MORNING, SARAH.
FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. JANICE O'MALLEY, AFSCME,
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
SAMANTHA, SAYING NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE SEEING NO ONE. ALL
RIGHT. LET'S NOW TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED
PLEASE COME UP. IF YOU WOULD
MIND. I THINK WE'RE GOING TO ASK
THE OPPOSITION IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY FROM THE TABLE. ALL
RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, MR. PRATT, THE
MICROPHONE IS YOURS. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD, MARK
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION TO AB
3129 ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENTS,
THE AMERICAN INVESTMENT COUNCIL
AND CHILDREN'S CHOICE, A
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION WE POSED TO
THE COMMITTEE IS WHEN DOES LESS
CAPITAL IN THE MARKETPLACE LOWER
PRICES? AND THIS MEASURE, WE
BELIEVE, WOULD THWART CAPITAL
FROM BEING INVESTED IN
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE? AB 3129
PICKS, WINNERS AND LOSERS
NOTWITHSTANDING, THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTH CARES
REGULATION OF OPTUM'S LICENSED
HEALTH PLAN TRANSACTIONS, DMHC
DOES NOT REGULATE ITS
ACQUISITION OF PHYSICIAN
PRACTICES. OPTUM, WHICH EMPLOYS
OVER 70,000 PHYSICIANS
NATIONWIDE, FINALIZED ITS
ACQUISITION OF BEAVER MEDICAL
GROUP IN 2022, ONE OF THE
LARGEST MULTI-SPECIALTY MEDICAL
GROUPS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE,
WITH MORE THAN 1300 EMPLOYEES,
INCLUDING 900 CLINICIANS. WHY
SHOULD CHILDREN'S CHOICE, A 33
LOCATION PEDIATRIC DENTAL
PRACTICE PROVIDING DENTAL CARE
IN UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES FOR
CHILDREN, HAVE TO COMPLY WITH
3129, BUT OPTUM DOES NOT. WE
SUBMIT THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
LOOKING TO PICK WINNERS AND
LOSERS. OKAY, IS THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY A Ã
ORGANIZATION FORMED IN 2022 BY
THE ENACTMENT OF SB 184,
PROVIDES A CLEAR STATEMENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENT THAT,
OKAY, IT IS THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ESTABLISH A
SINGLE ENTITY WITHIN STATE
GOVERNMENT CHARGED WITH
REFERRING TRANSACTIONS THAT MAY
REDUCE MARKET COMPETITION OR
INCREASE COST TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR FURTHER REVIEW.
FURTHER, THE DEFINITIONS OF THIS
BILL ARE IMPRECISE AND
INCONSISTENT. THIS IS NOT A BILL
THAT JUST COVERS PRIVATE EQUITY
AND HEDGE. IF ALL THE MEMBERS ON
THIS DAIS WISH TO POOL THEIR
FUNDS, THEY WOULD BE COVERED BY
THIS BILL. HOWEVER, ONE WEALTHY
INDIVIDUAL WOULD BE EXEMPT FROM
THE PROCESS. FINALLY, THE AG'S
AUTHORITY TO REVIEW AND CONSENT
REMAINS OVERLY BROAD. AND WE
BELIEVE MR. ALL RIGHT. WELL, WE
WOULD ASK FOR A NO VOTE. ALL
RIGHT. OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. CATHERINE AUSTIN
SCOTT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION, WE
UNDERSTAND THE AMENDMENTS WOULD
REMOVE FOR PROFIT HOSPITALS
LOOKING TO UNDERSTAND HOW THIS
WOULD AFFECT THEIR REMAINING
COUNTY HOSPITALS, BUT WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS AND WORK WITH THE
CHAIR. THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION. MR. CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS, MEGAN LOPER, ON BEHALF
OF THE UNITED HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. SIMILARLY, WE LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS AND UNDERSTANDING THE
EFFECT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. OUR
ATTORNEYS HAVE BEEN HAVING
POSITIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE ABOUT
EXEMPTING COUNTY HOSPITALS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS. I'M FRED NOWHERE,
REPRESENTING THE ASSOCIATION OF
DENTAL SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
, THANK YOU. PRESTON YOUNG FROM
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. OTHERS
KIM STONE OF STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ORTHOPEDIC ASSOCIATION, REMOVING
OPPOSITION AS OF THE LAST ROUND
OF AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU.
ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE.
LET'S BRING IT BACK. COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATOR ROTH HAS MOVED THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? YES, SENATOR LAIRD,
SENATOR BARRASSO, DID YOU WISH
TO. YES. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
LEAHY, FIRST, LET ME ASK A
QUESTION WHICH IS BECAUSE I GOT
HERE AFTER I THINK YOU SAID
YOU'D SAY THE AMENDMENT, TAKE
THE AMENDMENT OR AMENDMENTS.
WHAT'S THE IMPACT OF REMOVING
THE FOR PROFIT HOSPITALS FROM
THIS BILL? I KIND OF FEEL LIKE
THE IMPACT IS INSTEAD OF A FULL
LOAF OF BREAD, I GOT THREE
QUARTERS OF A LOAF OF BREAD. IN
OTHER WORDS, IT IS A HIT TO THE
BILL. I DO FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT
HOSPITALS SHOULD BE CONSIDERED,
THE FOR PROFIT HOSPITALS SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED. BUT I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE IN PARTICULAR, HAVE
BEEN WELL HAMMERED BY HOSPITALS
SAYING HOW AWFUL AND EVIL THIS
IS. AND, YOU KNOW, I RECOGNIZE
THAT I'D RATHER MAKE PROGRESS ON
THIS THAN THAN LOSE THIS, LOSE
THIS, THIS THIS THIS AREA WAS A
HUGE TOPIC OF CONCERN DURING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF. IT WAS THE ONE
PIECE WE COULDN'T GET ACROSS THE
LINE BECAUSE OF THE SAME KINDS
OF OPPOSITION FROM THE SAME
PLAYERS THAT WE ARE DEALING WITH
NOW, AND WE ARE STILL FIGHTING
ABOUT THAT GOING FORWARD. SO MY
HOPE IS THAT, THE OTHER ENTITIES
THAT WILL STILL BE INCLUDED
NURSING HOMES, OTHER PRACTICES,
CLINICAL LABS, WHATEVER, THAT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL CAN
DEMONSTRATE THAT THIS IS NOT THE
ONEROUS PROCESS THAT IS BEING
CLAIMED BY THE OPPOSITION AND
THAT THE OVERSIGHT IS WARRANTED
AND THAT THAT A GOOD OUTCOME CAN
HAPPEN, AND THAT AT SOME POINT,
SOMEBODY DOWN THE LINE CAN PICK
UP THE MANTLE AND MOVE THIS
ACROSS THE LINE FOR, FOR
HOSPITALS. AND, I TALKED TO I
THINK SOMETIME AROUND YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON, I COULD NO LONGER
RESPOND TO PEOPLE THAT WERE
INQUIRING ABOUT THIS BILL, BUT I
HAD CONVERSATIONS. AND ONE OF
THE CONVERSATIONS AMONG THE
OPPONENTS SAID THAT THEY
THOUGHT, OKAY, REALLY HAD A
PURPOSE THAT DIDN'T NECESSARILY
NECESSARILY NECESSITATE THIS
BILL BECAUSE YOU COULD FOLLOW.
OKAY. COULD YOU SPEAK TO THAT?
THAT IS REALLY, REALLY NOT TRUE.
OKAY. IS AFTER THE FACT, OKAY.
WILL REVIEW TRANSACTIONS AND
LOOK AT IMPACTS TO THE MARKET,
BUT THEY HAVE NO JURISDICTION TO
ACTUALLY AFFECT WHETHER THE
TRANSACTION CAN HAPPEN. WHAT WE
SIMPLY WANTED WAS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE AG TO LOOK
AT THIS. WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
OTHER STATES IS THAT AND WITH
OTHER ENTITIES IN CALIFORNIA. SO
I MEAN, IN FOR EXAMPLE,
HOSPITALS, THIS HAS HAPPENED IN
BACK EAST. THERE WAS ONE
HOSPITAL CHAIN THAT HAS NOW GONE
BANKRUPT, ABOUT 20 HOSPITALS,
ALL ACQUIRED BY PRIVATE EQUITY,
MY HOPE WAS THAT IF THAT WERE TO
BEGIN TO HAPPEN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
LOOK AT THAT PROACTIVELY AND
DETERMINE, YOU KNOW, WILL THESE
TRANSACTIONS LEAD TO POTENTIAL
PROBLEMS GOING FORWARD, DOESN'T
COVER THAT. IT SIMPLY DOESN'T.
AND IT'S BEEN A RED HERRING FROM
THE BEGINNING. AND IT'S
DISINGENUOUS TO SAY THAT, TO SAY
OTHERWISE, QUITE FRANKLY. THEN
LET ME GET TO THE COMMENT I WAS
GOING TO MAKE. AND YOU TEED IT
UP, BECAUSE I HAVE TWO HOSPITALS
IN MY DISTRICT THAT ARE SORT OF
TEXTBOOK CASES ABOUT THIS LAW,
AND THEY ARE ON DIFFERENT SIDES
OF THAT PROFIT NONPROFIT
EQUATION. THAT'S WHY I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE IT OUT WITH
WATSONVILLE, WHICH I THINK SOME
OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE PROBABLY
TIRED OF HEARING ME TALK ABOUT
THAT IS WHERE TWO YEARS AGO, A
PRIVATE EQUITY FIRM HAD ACQUIRED
IT AND RAN IT COMPLETELY INTO
THE GROUND. THEY, ANNOUNCED THEY
WERE GOING TO JUST CLOSE IT. 625
PEOPLE, THE ONLY HOSPITAL FOR A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY FOR
MILES. EITHER WAY. AND
FORTUNATELY, IT GOT KICKED INTO
BANKRUPTCY COURT SO THAT I COULD
DO A BILL IN A MATTER OF DAYS,
CREATING A PUBLIC HOSPITAL
DISTRICT, THE BANKRUPTCY COURT,
WITHIN A MATTER OF DAYS OF IT
BECOMING A DISTRICT, COULD
ACCEPT THE BID AND THEN WE
RAISED $65 MILLION OVER SIX
MONTHS. THEY'VE PASSED A BOND.
THEY'RE JUST BARELY MAKING IT.
BUT THEY'RE THERE AND THEY'RE
MAKING IT. AND IF THERE HAD BEEN
THE CHANCE TO EXAMINE A PRIVATE
EQUITY FIRM THAT HAD NEVER RUN A
HOSPITAL BEFORE, WE COULD SEE
COMING OUT THAT THAT WAS THE
CASE. NOW IN HOLLISTER WITH
HAZEL HAWKINS, IT IS A PUBLIC
DISTRICT. THEY ARE PURSUING A
PRIVATE PARTNER. I THINK,
FORTUNATELY FOR EVERYONE, IT HAS
TO GO TO THE VOTERS. AND I THINK
IN NOVEMBER I WILL BE REALLY
SURPRISED IF IT PASSES AND IT IS
THE OTHER WAY. THEY COULD, IN MY
VIEW, MANAGE THE HOSPITAL. IT
TAKE SOME TOUGH STEPS, BUT
MANAGE THE HOSPITAL AND FIGURE
OUT HOW TO GET THERE AND IF THIS
LEAVES NONPROFITS IN, THEN
THERE'S A CHANCE TO REVIEW THAT
IN A WAY THAT YOU COULD ASSESS
THAT SOMEBODY THAT'S OUT OF
STATE WITH LIMITED FINANCIAL
CAPABILITY AND DOESN'T KNOW THE
STATE, MIGHT NOT BE THE BEST
PERSON OR ENTITY TO TAKE OVER
THE HOSPITAL. SO THAT'S WHY I
THINK THIS BILL IS NECESSARY, IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOTHING TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES. AND WE SIT
THERE AND WATCH A HOSPITAL AND A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY JUST GO
COMPLETELY UNDER. AND WE HAVE A
SECOND ONE. WE'RE WATCHING THAT
COULD GO COMPLETELY UNDER. AND
WHILE I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
A VERY COMPLEX BILL AND THAT
THERE ARE THINGS IN IT THAT
ALWAYS MIGHT NEED SOME
TINKERING, I THINK THE CONCEPT
IS REALLY APPROPRIATE FOR THE
TIMES, AND I WILL BE VOTING FOR
THE BILL, WHEN WE GET TO THAT.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU,
SENATOR BARRASSO, THEN SENATOR
ROTH, THEN THEN ME. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR BARRASSO, I WANT TO
THANK YOU. THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING AND INTRODUCING THIS
BILL AND FOR CARING SO MUCH
ABOUT OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM,
HAVING THAT KIND OF VISION. I
JUST WANTED TO IF THERE IS
ANYTHING BESIDES THAT THE
OPPOSITION HAS RAISED THAT YOU
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMIND
US ABOUT, NO, ACTUALLY, YOU
KNOW, LIKE I SAID, HAS BEEN THE
FLASH POINT. WE WORK FOR TWO AND
A HALF YEARS, WORKED WITH
CLOSELY WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO GET ACROSS THE LINE, AND WE
HEARD MANY OF THE SAME DEBATES
AROUND THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE.
AND OKAY, ULTIMATELY, WE WEREN'T
SUCCESSFUL THERE. AND THAT'S
KIND OF WHY WE'RE LEANING ON
THIS AREA. BUT THIS UNLIKE OTHER
EFFORTS IN THE CONSOLIDATION
AREA, THIS IS VERY NARROWLY
FOCUSED BECAUSE THERE IS NO
OVERSIGHT AT ALL ON PRIVATE
EQUITY IN THE HEALTH CARE SPACE
PERIOD, PERIOD. AND IT IS IT IS
NOT AN EMERGING ISSUE. IT IS
HERE, AND IT IS CREATING
CHALLENGES FOR, FOR THE DELIVERY
OF HEALTH CARE. I THINK THE, THE
OTHER OPPOSITION IS THAT THIS
WILL SOMEHOW STIFLE INVESTMENT.
IT'S LIKE, NO, THIS WILL NOT
STIFLE INVESTMENT, BUT IT WILL
IT WILL LOOK AT IF THAT
INVESTMENT LEADS TO CONTROL OF
THE ENTITY. AND THAT'S THE KEY
THING. IF AN IF A PRIVATE IF A
IF SOMEONE WANTS TO COME IN AND
INVITE PRIVATE EQUITY TO INVEST
IN THEM, AS LONG AS THEY DON'T
TAKE CONTROL, THEY CAN DO THAT
AND THAT'S BEEN, THAT'S I THINK
THAT'S ALSO BEEN DISINGENUOUS
OPPOSITION THERE TOO, BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO STIFLE THAT
INVESTMENT. WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET IS OVERSIGHT. IF THAT
INVESTMENT LEADS TO CONTROL OF
THE ENTITY AND ALL THE POTENTIAL
CHALLENGES THAT THAT ENTITY WILL
FACE GOING FORWARD. AND THAT'S
SO I THINK, YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN
FIGHTING WHAT I FEEL AT TIMES
HAS BEEN REALLY DISINGENUOUS
OPPOSITION. AND, YOU KNOW, IT'S
BEEN A CHALLENGING TO GET ACROSS
BECAUSE IT IS A COMPLICATED
TOPIC. BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
QUESTIONS AND YOUR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ROTH. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. YOU
KNOW, TO RESPOND TO THE QUESTION
ON THE FOR PROFIT HOSPITALS, YOU
KNOW, THESE TEND TO BE LARGE.
THEY DON'T TEND TO BE VERY MANY
TRANSACTIONS. THEY TEND TO BE
RATHER HUGE TRANSACTIONS WHEN
THERE IS A SALE. THERE ALSO IS
THE FOR PROFIT MARKETPLACE. SO
THERE'S PROBABLY A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF AN EVEN PLAYING FIELD
WHEN THE PRIVATE EQUITY COMES TO
HEAD TO HEAD WITH A FOR PROFIT
HOSPITAL AND THE TEAM THAT THE
FOR PROFIT HAS SO I'M NOT TOO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ELIMINATION,
AT LEAST AT THIS POINT OF THE
FOR PROFIT HOSPITALS FROM THE
BILL. ALTHOUGH I KNOW THE AUTHOR
IS EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTED, I'VE
SPENT A FAIR AMOUNT OF TIME ON
THIS BILL, AND THIS ISSUE IN
ANOTHER CONTEXT, I WILL SAY
THIS. I DON'T THINK ALL PRIVATE
EQUITY IS EQUAL, AND I THINK
THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE
PRIVATE EQUITY PROBABLY BRINGS
SOMETHING TO THE TABLE,
PARTICULARLY WHERE WE'RE TRYING
TO FUND SEISMIC RETROFIT AND A
VARIETY OF OTHER THINGS. IN THE
HEALTH CARE ARENA WHERE WE'RE
TRYING TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN OUR
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS LIKE
THE CENTRAL VALLEY, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, YOU KNOW, AND THE
OPPOSITION KNOWS, BECAUSE I'VE
SAID THIS TO THEM, I HAVE ASKED
FOR CLARIFYING LANGUAGE FOR THIS
BILL TO TRY TO SEPARATE OUT
PRIVATE EQUITY FROM THE GOOD AND
THE BAD, WHAT THE BAD TECHNIQUES
ARE, WHAT THE GOOD TECHNIQUES
ARE, WHAT TECHNIQUES CAUSE
PROBLEMS FOR OTHERS, INCLUDING
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND I HAVE
YET TO SEE ANY LANGUAGE. SO I
GUESS WHAT WILL HAPPEN HERE IS
SHOULD THIS BILL PASS OUT AND I
HOPE IT DOES, THAT WE WILL SEE
THE IMPACT OF THE BILL, THE
ACTIONS OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
AND WE WILL BE ABLE TO SORT OUT
AS LEGISLATORS, THOSE WHO ARE
STILL HERE, WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO TWEAK THIS BILL TO ALLOW
PRIVATE EQUITY INVESTMENT WHERE
IT BENEFITS THE HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM AND CONTINUE TO
REIGN IT IN WHERE IT DOES NOT.
SO THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, FOR
ALLOWING ME TO MAKE MY COMMENTS.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ROTH. SENATOR
WILK. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I
AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS OF
SENATOR ROTH THAT THERE IS GOOD
EQUITY AND BAD EQUITY. AND I
HAVE SEEN THE EQUITY FIRMS COME
IN AND DO HORRIBLE THINGS,
PARTICULARLY IN HOUSING SPACE IN
MY DISTRICT. BUT THEY'RE ALSO
YOU NEED YOU NEED CAPITAL TO
SURVIVE. WE'VE BEEN ASKING KIND
OF I DON'T WANT TO SAY THEIR ONE
SIDED QUESTIONS, BUT KIND OF
TEEING IT UP FOR THE AUTHOR,
WHICH IS FINE. BUT, MR. PERRY,
DO YOU WANT TO COMMENT AT ALL ON
WHAT'S BEEN DISCUSSED? I I,
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
ENGAGEMENT WITH US AS WELL AS
THE COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF. I
WANT TO DIFFER WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOOD ON ONE POINT AS TO
WHETHER IS AFTER THE FACT. SO
WHEN A TRANSACTION THAT'S
COVERED BY OCA IS SUBMITTED TO
OCA, IT HAS TO BE DONE 90 DAYS
PRIOR TO THE TRANSACTION.
FURTHERMORE, OCA HAS THE ABILITY
TO REQUIRE THAT THAT THE
APPLICANT PROVIDE THEM ANSWERS
TO QUESTIONS THAT THEY MAY HAVE
AND MAY EXTEND THAT 90 DAYS, YOU
KNOW, BY A SIGNIFICANT TERM. AND
SO THE IDEA THAT THIS, THAT OCA
ONLY LOOKS AT THINGS IN THE REAR
VIEW MIRROR, I BELIEVE IS NOT
CORRECT, THAT IT IS PROSPECTIVE
AND THAT DURING THAT TIME THAT
OCA THEN WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY, IF THEY SEE THAT
THERE'S AN OVERCONCENTRATION IN
THE MARKETPLACE OR THAT THERE IS
A, A RISK TO EXCEEDING THE PRICE
CAPS THAT OCA HAS, WHICH FOR
2025 IS 3.5% AND LOWERS DOWN TO
3% IN 2029, THAT THEY HAVE THE
OBLIGATION AND THE ABILITY TO
REFER THAT MATTER TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR THEIR
REVIEW. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS? NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONCE AGAIN, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOOD, MR. PERRY HAS
RAISED SOME IMPORTANT POINTS,
AND I KNOW YOU PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS. THE
ISSUE CONCERNING DEFINITIONS IS
AN IMPORTANT ONE, AS IT LEAVES
THE LEGISLATURE AS I EXPECT IT.
WELL, AND IN TERMS OF PRIVATE
EQUITY, THE POINT ABOUT
ADDITIONAL CAPITAL BEING
INVESTED IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
HEALTH CARE MARKET IS A IS A
CRITICAL QUESTION, ONE THAT WE
STRUGGLED WITH YOU AND I
STRUGGLED WITH. AND I THINK THE
STATE STRUGGLES WITH AND THE
EFFICACY OF ANY SORT OF APPROVAL
IS SOMETHING THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO WATCH TO, TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE NOT UNNECESSARILY
STIFLING PROGRESS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, NOT UNNECESSARILY
STIFLING CAPITAL FROM BEING
INVESTED HERE IN THE HEALTH CARE
INDUSTRY. SO, WITH THAT, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES, FIRST OF
ALL, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, THANK
YOU TO SENATOR ROTH FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL AND SENATE
HEALTH. I REALLY APPRECIATE IT,
I THINK YOU KNOW, THE OPPOSITION
AND I ARE GOING TO AGREE TO
DISAGREE ON THINGS THAT IS, YOU
KNOW, OKAY, CAN MAKE A REFERRAL
TO THE AG, BUT THEN THE AG HAS
NO AUTHORITY TO, APPROVE OR
DISAPPROVE OF THE TRANSACTION,
TO THE BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE. AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO ESTABLISH HERE, I DON'T HAVE
I ABSOLUTELY AGREE THERE ARE
THERE'S GOOD PRIVATE EQUITY AND
BAD EQUITY, PRIVATE EQUITY. I
THINK IT'S INCUMBENT ON US TO
REALLY BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THE
SITUATION AND TRY TO MAKE A BEST
DETERMINATION AS TO WHAT IS GOOD
AND WHAT IS BAD. AND THERE IS
THERE ARE TRACK RECORDS FOR
ORGANIZATIONS OUT THERE THAT
THAT GIVE US THAT OPPORTUNITY,
THAT INITIAL TRANSACTION WHERE
HE SAID THAT IF MR. PERRY SAID
THAT IF A GROUP WANTED TO GET
TOGETHER AND BUY SOMETHING, THAT
WOULD BE CONSIDERED PRIVATE
EQUITY, THE FIRST TRANSACTION
WOULD BE EXEMPT. IT'S THE SECOND
AND THIRD TRANSACTIONS WITHIN
SEVEN YEARS THAT WOULD BE LOOKED
AT. AND THAT IS I THINK THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
POINT. AND THEN WITH REGARDS TO
CHILDREN'S CHOICE, MY
UNDERSTANDING IS, IS THAT MOSTLY
HOW THEY OPERATE IS BUYING IS
NOT BUYING PRACTICES. IT'S
BUILDING NEW PRACTICES. AND I
HAVE NO OBJECTION IF PRIVATE
EQUITY WANTS TO COME IN AND
BUILD SOMETHING FROM THE GROUND
UP. IT'S WHEN YOU BEGIN TO
ACCUMULATE PRACTICES AND THEN
HAVE THAT UNDUE INFLUENCE TO
CREATE AN UNCOMPETITIVE,
MARKETPLACE FOR HEALTH CARE THAT
THAT THE PROBLEMS ARISE. AND SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN. I
APPRECIATE, APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION AND THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALRIGHTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE A
MOTION? YES. I'M SORRY. SENATOR
ROTH MOVES THE BILL. SENATOR
ROTH HAS MOVED THE BILL. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB
3129. THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG
UMBERG. AYE. WILK. NØ. WILK NO.
ALLEN ASHBY. CABALLERO. DURAZZO.
DURAZZO AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE.
NHIÀU MILO. NO. ROTH. ROTH AYE.
STERN. WAHAB. 4 TO 2. THREE.
FOUR. TWO. WE'LL PUT THAT ON.
CALL YOUR NEXT BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ITEM NUMBER
FOUR. NØ. I'M SORRY. FILE NUMBER
THREE, AB 3218. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, GOOD MORNING
ONCE AGAIN. I'D FIRST LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR EFFORTS ON THIS MEASURE.
STATE LAW PROHIBITS FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, THEY REMAIN
READILY AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THE HIGH RATE OF FLAVORED
TOBACCO USE AMONG YOUTH IS
ESPECIALLY CONCERNING. A 2023
STUDY BY THE CDC INDICATES THAT
AMONG MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS WHO USE TOBACCO, NEARLY
90% USE FLAVORED PRODUCTS. AB
3218 CREATES A PATHWAY TO
ENSURING FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS ARE NO LONGER AVAILABLE
ON THE SHELVES OF RETAILERS AND
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. BY CREATING
AN AFFIRMATIVE LISTING OF
UNFLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS
LEGAL IN CALIFORNIA, THIS
APPROACH WILL HELP RETAILERS
DETERMINE AT A GLANCE WHETHER
PRODUCT DELIVERED TO THEIR
STORES IS LEGAL OR NOT.
ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL
AUTHORIZES THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO PENALIZE DISTRIBUTORS THAT
SELL ILLEGAL TOBACCO PRODUCTS
AND MANUFACTURERS THAT FALSELY
CERTIFY THEIR PRODUCTS ARE
UNFLAVORED AND FINALLY, THE BILL
AUTHORIZES AUTHORIZES LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO SEIZE ILLEGAL
TOBACCO PRODUCTS. THESE
COMPREHENSIVE ENFORCEMENT STEPS
WILL HELP IMPLEMENT THE FLAVORED
TOBACCO PLAN THE WAY IT WAS
INTENDED HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS TIFFANY BROKAW
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE, THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL,
BYRON MILLER, WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE, IS ALSO
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
MISS BROKAW. GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
TIFFANY, I THINK IT'S ON, RIGHT.
BROKAW DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND LEGISLATURA, YOU MAY NEED TO
JUST PULL A LITTLE CLOSER. THERE
WE GO. OH, PERFECT. OKAY, THANKS
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. TIFFANY
BROKAW, DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL ROB BONTA, WHO IS THE
PROUD SPONSOR OF AB 3218, ALONG
WITH OUR CO-SPONSORS CAMPAIGN
FOR TOBACCO FREE KIDS, THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION, THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY, AND THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION. AS
DOCTOR WOOD MENTIONED, THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FLAVORED
TOBACCO BAN. WHEN THE BAN WENT
INTO EFFECT, OUR OFFICE RECEIVED
A NUMBER OF INQUIRIES ASKING FOR
GUIDANCE AND ASSISTANCE IN
EFFECTUATING THE ROLLOUT OF THE
LAW. OUR OFFICE DRAFTED AB 3218.
IN RESPONSE TO THESE INQUIRIES
AND AS A NEXT STEP IN
ACCOMPLISHING THE BAND'S POLICY
GOALS OF GETTING THESE FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF OUR YOUTH. AB 3218 WILL
ESTABLISH A PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
LIST OF ALL TOBACCO PRODUCTS
THAT ARE PERMISSIBLY, UNFLAVORED
AND ALLOWED TO BE SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA. THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SUCH A LIST HAS LONG BEEN A
RECOMMENDATION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES, WHO HAVE LOOKED AT
OUR OFFICE'S TOBACCO DIRECTORY
LIST AS A LEADING EXAMPLE OF HOW
A PUBLICIZED CURATED LIST CAN
PROVIDE CLARITY TO INDUSTRY
PARTICIPANTS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
ON WHAT PRODUCTS CAN AND CANNOT
BE SOLD. THIS BILL WILL ALSO
RENDER ILLEGAL FLAVORED PRODUCTS
CONTRABAND SO THAT SUCH PRODUCTS
CAN BE QUICKLY REMOVED FROM
COMMERCE AND NEVER REACH OUR
KIDS. IT WILL HOLD THE
DISTRIBUTION CHAIN ACCOUNTABLE
AT A HIGHER LEVEL. IT WILL
CLARIFY THE DEFINITION OF
CHARACTERIZING FLAVOR TO
SPECIFICALLY PROHIBIT PRODUCTS
THAT IMPART MENTHOL LIKE COOLING
SENSATIONS. OUR OFFICE SAW THAT
AFTER THE FLAVOR BAN WENT INTO
EFFECT, NEW TOBACCO PRODUCTS
WERE INTRODUCED TO THE MARKET
THAT WERE AIMED TO WORK AROUND
THE BAN. SO BY CLARIFYING THE
DEFINITION, THIS BAN WILL
ENCOMPASS THESE EDGE AND WORK
AROUND PRODUCTS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUBJECT TO DEBATE AND
LITIGATION. AND LASTLY, AB 3218
WILL ALSO AUTHORIZE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO OMIT FROM THE
UNFLAVORED LIST ANY TOBACCO
PRODUCTS LACKING THE REQUIRED
FDA AUTHORIZATION. AB 3218 WOULD
HOLD. THANK YOU. OKAY. ALRIGHTY.
THANKS. THANK YOU. YOU URGE AND
I VOTE YES. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
TIM GIBBS CAMPAIGN FOR TOBACCO
FREE KIDS PROUD CO-SPONSOR JAMIE
MORGAN, PROUD CO-SPONSOR ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION. KELLY BROOKS, ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HERE
IN SUPPORT AUTUMN OGDEN SMITH
WITH THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY
CANCER ACTION NETWORK PROUD
CO-SPONSOR IN SUPPORT. OH, NO,
I'M RIGHT BEHIND HIM, KATHY
MCDONALD FOR THE COUNTY OF
ALAMEDA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LISA BRUCE, AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, BRANDON MAKI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. KELLY MCMILLAN ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT. PLEASE
APPROACH SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING OPPOSITION. YOU'RE
WELCOME TO SIT AT THE TABLE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS JOHN WENGER, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FUELS AND
CONVENIENCE ALLIANCE, WE
REPRESENT THE MAJORITY OF GAS
STATIONS AND CONVENIENCE STORES
IN THE STATE. FIRST AND
FOREMOST, OUR CFCA SUPPORTS
CREATING A DIRECTORY THAT GIVES
OUR MEMBERS CLARITY ON WHAT WE
CAN AND CANNOT BE, CANNOT SELL,
HOWEVER, WE CONTINUE TO HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL. I THINK WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE BROAD
DISCRETION FOR THE AG TO BE ABLE
TO PULL LEGAL PRODUCTS OFF THE
OFF THE LIST, AND WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE EXPANSION
OF THE DEFINITION OF
CHARACTERIZING FLAVOR THAT WE
THINK IS OVERLY BROAD AND COULD
RESULT IN MORE PRODUCTS BEING
PULLED OFF THE SHELVES, WHICH
WILL JUST BOLSTER THE ILLICIT
ILLICIT MARKET EVEN FURTHER. AND
SO, UNFORTUNATELY, WHILE WE
SUPPORT THE DIRECTORY, WE DO
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL AND HAVING OPPOSED LAST
AMENDED POSITION. ALRIGHTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE, LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS,
IS THERE A MOTION? SENATOR WILK
HAS MOVED THE BILL. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. JUST A COMMENT
TO THE OPPOSITION. THERE ARE
VERY FEW LEGAL PRODUCTS ACTUALLY
APPROVED FOR SALE, THE FDA HAS A
THOUSAND, SEVERAL THOUSAND
PRODUCTS THAT THEY ARE UNDER
REVIEW, THEY HAVE CHOSEN NOT TO
ENFORCE AGAINST THOSE PRODUCTS,
BUT THEY ARE NOT CONSIDERED
LEGAL PRODUCTS. AND SO, I HAVE
NO PROBLEM WITH LEGAL PRODUCTS,
BUT THESE OTHER PRODUCTS ARE
NOT. AND UNTIL THE FDA APPROVES
THEM, THEY'RE NOT CONSIDERED
LEGAL FOR SALE AND THAT SO
ANYWAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
THAT'S IT. ALL RIGHT. WELL,
THANK YOU SO THIS IS A
CHALLENGING ANOTHER CHALLENGING
SITUATION. NOT QUITE AS
CHALLENGING AS THE ONE BEFORE AS
THE BILL BEFORE. I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S A MILLION PENDING
APPLICATIONS AT THE FDA FOR
APPROVAL OF PRODUCTS THAT WERE
NOT ORIGINALLY REQUIRED TO GET
PRIOR APPROVAL UNDER EXISTING
LAW, ON BALANCE, I THINK THE
STATE SHOULD GIVE SOME DEFERENCE
TO THE FDA'S EXERCISE OF
PROSECUTORIAL DISCRETION WHEN
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL USES HIS
OWN DISCRETION, HOWEVER, I THINK
IT'S UNWISE TO STATUTORILY ENACT
THE FDA'S CURRENT PROSECUTORIAL
STANCE INTO STATE STATUTE, AS
IT'S NOT STATIC AND COULD CHANGE
IN THE FUTURE. SO I HOPE THAT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL
CONSIDER THE FDA'S POLICY IN
MAKING ITS OWN JUDGMENT AS TO
WHAT SHOULD BE APPROVED, NOT
APPROVED, AND WITH THAT, THERE'S
A QUESTION OR A MOTION QUESTION
QUESTION. I THINK YOU GOT A I
THINK YOU HAVE A MOTION. CHEN
WILK. SENATOR WILK. THAT'S
RIGHT. MAY I ASK A QUESTION? MR.
SURE. SO I'M JUST CURIOUS. SO WE
HAVE UNFLAVORED PRODUCTS. THE
FDA HAS NOT BLESSED THEM, AND
LET'S SAY THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT THEY'RE UNFLAVORED. THERE'S
NOT EVEN A NOTHING IN THERE THAT
OTHER THAN TOBACCO, ARE THOSE
CAPABLE OF BEING, YOU KNOW,
YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE CIGAR
PEOPLE, FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN THERE
ARE OTHERS, I'M SURE. CAN THOSE
PRODUCTS BE SOLD? YOU KNOW, I
THERE BE I WOULD SAY THAT'S UP
TO THE DISCRETION OF THE, OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. IF A COMPANY
HAS CERTIFIED TO THE FDA THAT
THEIR PRODUCTS ARE UNFLAVORED,
THE, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, LIKE
THE FDA, COULD NOT ENFORCE UNTIL
THERE'S AN ACTUAL PROOF THAT
THEY ARE SO I'M ASSUMING, I
SHOULDN'T ASSUME ANYTHING, BUT
THAT WHEN A WHEN A WHEN AN
ENTITY CERTIFIES THAT THEIR
PRODUCT IS UNFLAVORED TO THE
FDA, THERE IS A PENALTY FOR THEM
IF THAT IS NOT TRUE, ONE OF
WHICH WOULD BE, YOU KNOW, THE
LOSS OF THE PRODUCT TO THE
MARKET. AND SO I THINK THE FEAR
IS THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WOULD OVER ENFORCE IN THIS AND
I, I DON'T HAVE THAT FEAR, QUITE
FRANKLY, I'M MORE CONCERNED
THAT, THAT THE TRULY FLAVORED
PRODUCTS THAT ARE OUT ON THE
MARKET ARE, ARE NOT AVAILABLE,
ARE PULLED OFF THE MARKET AND
NOT AVAILABLE. AND SO REALLY
THE, THE REALLY THE PREMISE HERE
IS TO CREATE AN AFFIRMATIVE LIST
WHICH, WHICH, WHICH WE ARE
TRYING TO DO, AND I CAN'T WE
CAN'T, WE CAN'T COMPEL THE FDA
TO DO MOVE FASTER. ON THIS AND
I'M, I'M COMFORTABLE WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL USING HIS
DISCRETION AND FOLLOWING THE
LEAD OF THE FDA. WELL, I TEND TO
AGREE WITH YOU IN THE FIRST
PLACE. THERE'S STILL A TON OF
PEOPLE WHO I SUSPECT STILL SMOKE
. AND IF UNFLAVORED PRODUCTS ARE
BANNED OR THERE'S AN ATTEMPT TO
DO SO, I'M SURE THERE'LL BE AN
UPROAR IN THE PUBLIC. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, IT WILL CAUSE A
COMMERCIAL DISRUPTION TO THE
COMMERCIAL MARKET, WHICH WE
PROBABLY DON'T WANT EITHER. SO I
SUSPECT IT'S ALL GOING TO SORT
ITSELF OUT. THANK YOU FOR
TOLERATING MY QUESTION AND FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. MR. CHAIR. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ROTH. ALL RIGHT.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION BY SENATOR
, SENATOR, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. AYE, VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS FILE,
ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB 3218, THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS, BERG I WILK I
WILK. AYE. ALLEN. ASHBY.
CABALLERO DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE.
LAIRD LAIRD. AYE. NIELLO. NIELLO
NO. ROTH. ROTH. AYE. STERN
WAHAB. 5 TO 1 FIVE ONE. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT,
A COUPLE OF THINGS. ONE, LET'S
GO AHEAD. IF THERE'S A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR, SENATOR
DROSSOS MOVED THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, AND WE'RE GOING TO
SWITCH THINGS UP A LITTLE BIT.
I'M GOING TO CALL
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S, WICKS. IF YOU
WOULD, COME UP AND THEN WE'LL GO
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON.
IMMEDIATELY AFTERWARDS, WE'RE
GOING TO TALK FOR JUST A SECOND,
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO FIRST WE'RE
GOING TO DO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THEN NUMBER ONE I'M
SORRY, DID WE DO ONE. DID WE
TAKE A VOTE ON ONE. SURE, SURE
SURE. OKAY. WE'LL DO ITEM NUMBER
ONE. AND THEN WE'LL GO TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SO ONE FIRST.
YES NEED A MOTION ON FILE. ITEM
NUMBER ONE. SENATOR LAIRD HAS
MOVED IT. OKAY. FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB 2889. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WILK
NOT VOTING. ALLEN ASHBY.
CABALLERO DURAZZO. RUSSELL. AYE.
LAIRD LAIRD. AYE. NIELLO.
NIELLO. NO ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
STERN. WAHAB FOUR TO 1 OR 1.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT, THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DURAZZO ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WILK. AYE WILK. AYE. ALLEN.
ASHBY. CABALLERO DURAZZO. AYE
RUSSELL. AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE
NIELLO. NIELLO. AYE. ROTH. ROTH.
AYE STERN. WAHAB. 6 TO 0 AND
CONSENT SIX ZERO. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. I'M
GOING TO TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO,
SENATOR WILK AND SENATOR WILK,
IF YOU WOULD ASSUME THE
CHAIRMANSHIP, I'LL BE BACK IN
JUST A SECOND.
ALL RIGHT. NEXT IS FILED. ITEM
SIX AB 1949 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS WITH A RECOMMENDATION OF
Dð PASS TO PASS IS AMENDED. DO
PASS, AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WITH THAT, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, FIRST, I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR HIS
PERSONAL ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
BILL. AND SHOULD HE RETURN, I
WILL THANK HIM PERSONALLY WHEN
HE GETS BACK, AND ALSO WANT TO
DISCUSS WITH HIM SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS, BUT I'M TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS TODAY, INCLUDING THE
KNOWLEDGE STANDARD, WITH UNDER
THE PREMISE OF THE CONVERSATION
THAT THE CHAIR AND I HAD AROUND,
YOU KNOW, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND I WILL BE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH HIM OVER THE BREAK AS THIS
BILL, SHOULD IT PASS, MOVES INTO
APPROPRIATIONS TO ENSURE THAT
THE TERM CANNOT BE INTERPRETED
AND APPLIED TO AFFORD BLANKET
IMMUNITY TO THE PLATFORM. SO I
THINK THERE'S STILL SOME WORK TO
DO. AND OBVIOUSLY WE'LL WANT TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE AS WELL
AS THE CHAIR ON THAT, BUT I'M
HAPPY TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
WITH HIM TO, IF HE RETURNS IN
TIME, FOLLOWING THE
INVESTIGATION OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL BONTA IN 2023, IT WAS
REVEALED THAT META KNOWS THAT
ITS SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS ARE
USED BY MILLIONS OF CHILDREN
UNDER THE AGE OF 13, INCLUDING
AT ONE POINT ABOUT 30% OF ALL 10
TO 12 YEAR OLDS. AND IT
UNLAWFULLY COLLECTS THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION AS AMENDED.
AB 1949 WILL HELP TO ENSURE WILL
HELP TO KEEP CHILDREN UNDER 18
AND THEIR DAD IS SAFE FROM BEING
COLLECTED AND EXPLOITED WITHOUT
PARENTAL CONSENT. THE MEASURE
WILL PROHIBIT BUSINESSES FROM
COLLECTING, USING OR DISCLOSING
THE PERSONAL INFORMATION OF
CALIFORNIANS UNDER 18 WITHOUT
AFFIRMATIVE AUTHORIZATION FOR
USERS UNDER 13, AFFIRM
AFFIRMATIVE APPROVAL MUST COME
FROM A PARENT. OPPOSITION WILL
CONTEND THAT THIS WILL
UNCONSTITUTIONALLY RESTRICT
TEENS AND ADULTS ACCESS TO
LAWFUL SPEECH. TO BE CLEAR, AB
1949 DOES NOT REGULATE CONTENT.
SPEECH OR ACCESS TO CONTENT OR
SPEECH. THE AGE REQUIREMENT
DETERMINED DETERMINES WHAT
PRIVACY AND DATA COLLECTION
POLICIES APPLY TO THE SPECIFIC
USER. THE DATA AT ISSUE IN THIS
BILL CONCERNS A VULNERABLE
POPULATION THAT SHOULD BE GIVEN
ELEVATED PROTECTION. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
BUSINESSES CAN APPLY THE
REQUIREMENTS OF 1849 TO ALL
CONSUMERS, NOT ONLY TO MINORS,
THEREBY ELIMINATING ANY
REQUIREMENT TO EMPLOY AGE
ASSURANCE TOOLS IF NOT ALREADY.
BUSINESSES SHOULD ELEVATE THEIR
DATA COLLECTION PRACTICES AND
DETERMINE WHAT IS NECESSARY TO
OPERATE, RATHER THAN WHAT IS
SUITABLE FOR PROFITS, YOU KNOW,
I, I'VE DONE A NUMBER OF BILLS
IN THIS SPACE, YOU KNOW, AND
I'VE COME TO THIS AS A MOM. I'VE
GOT A FOUR YEAR OLD, ALMOST FOUR
YEAR OLD. HER BIRTHDAY IS NEXT
MONTH, AND A SEVEN YEAR OLD. AND
AS I SEE HOW THEY ARE ENGAGING
IN THE WORLD, IT'S A WHOLE
DIFFERENT WORLD THAN WHEN WE
WERE KIDS, AND I'M. I'M NOT A
LUDDITE. MY CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS
TO SCREEN TIME AND WE HAVE
REGULATIONS AROUND THAT, BUT I
STRONGLY BELIEVE OUR NUMBER ONE
JOB AS LAWMAKERS IS TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFE. SPECIFICALLY
OUR MOST VULNERABLE, WHICH ARE
OUR CHILDREN, AND SO I AGAIN,
I'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK IN THIS
SPACE. TO ME, THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO GUARD THEIR PRIVACY
AND PROTECT THEIR PRIVACY. I'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY
COLLABORATIVELY WITH OUR
SPONSORS, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE, WHO ALSO, HAS DEEP
CONCERN ABOUT THIS, THEY'RE
GOING TO BE HERE TO TESTIFY, I
DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE NOW THAT
THE CHAIR IS BACK, CHAIR UMBERG.
I MENTIONED EARLIER RIGHT BEFORE
YOU HAD LEFT. I'LL BE TAKING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TODAY, BUT
AS YOU AND I DISCUSSED, I WANTED
TO KEEP WORKING ON THE KNOWLEDGE
STANDARD BECAUSE I DON'T WANT IT
TO BE SOMETHING THAT'S BLANKET
IMMUNITY FOR THE PLATFORMS. SO I
KNOW YOU AND I TALKED ABOUT THAT
PRIVATELY. I WANTED TO PUT THAT
ON THE RECORD HERE FOR
COMMITTEE, THOUGH. WE'VE DONE
THIS DANCE BEFORE, AND YOU'RE A
GOOD PARTNER IN ALL OF THIS. SO
I LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS. AND
SORRY FOR BLOWING UP YOUR BREAK,
BUT I KNOW WE'LL HAVE MORE
CONVERSATIONS ON THAT. WELL, YOU
WON'T BE THE ONLY ONE, SO. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. GREAT AND WITH
THAT, MY I'LL LET MY WITNESSES
TESTIFY. GO AHEAD. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M AMY ALI, A DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HERE ON
BEHALF OF ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB
BONTA, WHO IS PROUD TO SPONSOR
AB 1940 1949, THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S DATA PRIVACY ACT,
WITH OUR ESTEEMED AUTHOR,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS, THANK YOU
FOR LEADING ON THIS BILL. AND
IT'S A SIMPLE, GRACEFUL SOLUTION
TO STRENGTHEN DATA PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS FOR CHILDREN AND
IMPROVE CHILD SAFETY ONLINE. AB
1949 FILLS A GAP IN CALIFORNIA
LAW AS PART OF A LARGER EFFORT
TO CREATE A SAFER ONLINE
ENVIRONMENT FOR CALIFORNIA'S
KIDS, USING ALL OF OUR TOOLS,
FROM THE COURTHOUSE TO THE
CAPITOL TO STOP A RACE AMONG
MASSIVE CORPORATIONS TO COLLECT
AND USE KIDS DATA FOR PROFIT.
LAST FALL, ATTORNEY GENERAL
BONTA, ALONG WITH STATE
ATTORNEYS GENERAL FROM ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, SUED META FOR
MISLEADING USERS AND PUTTING
CHILDREN IN HARMS WAY. OUR
LAWSUIT ALLEGES THAT THE COMPANY
VIOLATED FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS,
DISREGARDING SERIOUS DANGERS
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF SOCIAL MEDIA
USE ON KIDS MENTAL HEALTH,
BUILDING A BUSINESS MODEL
FOCUSED ON MAXIMIZING YOUNG
USERS TIME ON THE PLATFORM,
EMPLOYING HARMFUL AND
PSYCHOLOGICALLY MANIPULATIVE
PLATFORM FEATURES, AND LYING
ABOUT IT. THIS ONE COMPANY'S
CONDUCT IS DECEPTIVE, DANGEROUS
AND ILLEGAL, AND IT IS JUST ONE
PIECE OF A REALLY SIGNIFICANT
CRISIS FACING OUR CHILDREN. OUR
CHILDREN SPEND MORE AND MORE
TIME ONLINE IN FRONT OF SCREENS
FOR SCHOOL PLAY,
SELF-EXPRESSION, CONNECTION AND
EXPLORATION. THAT TIME SPENT
ONLINE HAS A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH, THEIR
ABILITY TO LEARN, AND TO SLEEP,
THEIR FEELINGS OF EXCLUSION AND
SUSCEPTIBILITY TO ADDICTION. THE
COLLECTION AND EXPLOITATION OF
CHILDREN'S PERSONAL INFORMATION
IS IN LARGE PART WHAT ENABLES
BUSINESSES TO HARNESS THE
ALGORITHMIC DELIVERY OF CONTENT
DESIGNED TO LEAD TO SOCIAL MEDIA
ADDICTION AND CHILDREN, AND
DRIVE UP COMPANY PROFITS IN THE
PROCESS. IN ADDITION TO ADVERSE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE TIME SPENT
ONLINE, THE COLLECTION OF
CHILDREN'S DATA BY THESE GIANT
COMPANIES ITSELF ALSO PUTS OUR
KIDS AT GRAVE RISK, LEAVING THEM
VULNERABLE TO HAVING THEIR
LOCATION AND OTHER PERSONAL DATA
TRACKED SHARED. THANK YOU ONLINE
YOU URGE AND I VOTE GREAT. THANK
YOU. I WILL SAY NO MORE. ALL
RIGHT. OTHERS OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS KIM
STONE. STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF THE CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
INSTITUTE IN ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR MEMBERS. SYMPHONY
BARBIE, ON BEHALF OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. REBECCA KRAMER MATTER ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION, WE HAD A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION. WE'RE
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS, BUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CRYSTAL
STRAIGHT ON BEHALF OF COMMON
SENSE MEDIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO ONE
ELSE APPROACHING, LET'S TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 1949, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE OR THE
TABLE, WHICHEVER YOU CHOOSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, CHAIR
MEMBERS. AND THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR. ROANOKE DAYLAMI WITH CAL
CHAMBER RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 1949. OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES DO TAKE
SERIOUSLY THE PRIVACY RIGHTS,
ESPECIALLY OF CHILDREN, BUT WE
HAVE HAD SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
WITH THIS BILL IN PRINT, AS IT
WOULD HAVE THE OPPOSITE EFFECT
INTENDED, AS IT MAKES IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR A BUSINESS TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE UNLESS IT
ENGAGES IN AGE VERIFICATION. TO
THAT END, WE DO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR FOR THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS
PENDING REVIEW OF THE OFFICIAL
LANGUAGE. OF COURSE, WE BELIEVE
THAT BY VIRTUE OF REINSTATING
THE ACTUAL KNOWLEDGE STANDARD,
THE AMENDMENTS VASTLY REDUCE
MANY OF OUR CONCERNS. DESPITE
OUR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN
PRINT, WE DO SEE A PATH FORWARD
WHERE AN AB 1949 MEANINGFULLY
STRENGTHENS CHILDREN'S PRIVACY
RIGHTS IN A MORE BALANCED MANNER
THAT CAN BE MORE READILY
OPERATIONALIZED BY BUSINESSES
WITHOUT POSING UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES TO GET THERE.
HOWEVER, WE DO BELIEVE THAT THE
OTHER PROVISIONS RELATED TO THE
COLLECTION USE AND DISCLOSURE
SECTION 1790 8.100 AND .121 THAT
THOSE NEED TO REVERT TO EXISTING
LAW, BUT THAT SAID, AGAIN, WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND LOOKING AT THE
AMENDMENTS, INCLUDING SOME OF
THE LANGUAGE AROUND ACTUAL
KNOWLEDGE, BUT WE DO OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHTY. THANK
YOU. NEXT PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS. DAWN KOEPKE, ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPUTER AND
COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. TRACY ROSENBERG WITH
OAKLAND PRIVACY, WE WERE
OPPOSED. UNLESS AMENDED, WILL BE
TAKING A LOOK AT THE AMENDMENTS.
WE THINK IT'S VERY POSSIBLE
WE'LL BE ABLE TO DROP OUR
OPPOSITION, BUT NOT QUITE SURE
YET. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. DYLAN
HOFFMAN, ON BEHALF OF TECHNET,
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
CHAMBER. RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MARK, WITH
AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION OPPOSED
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHARGING ON BEHALF OF THE
FRONTIER FOUNDATION IN
OPPOSITION UNTIL WE REMOVE THE
AMENDMENTS. ALL RIGHTY. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO OTHERS
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE,
LET'S NOW BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATOR WILK
YEAH, I DON'T I DON'T HAVE A
QUESTION. I JUST I JUST HAVE A
COMMENT. THIS IS A GREAT BILL
PLAN IS SUPPORTED TODAY. WE'VE
GOT TO PROTECT WE'VE GOT TO
PROTECT THESE KIDS AND WE DON'T
DO A VERY GOOD JOB. I WANT TO
SHARE SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED TO
ME EARLIER THIS YEAR, WHICH I
FOUND OFFENSIVE. SO I HAD A
HEALTH SCARE. ENDS UP I'M OKAY,
BUT I GOT MY INFORMATION BACK
FROM MY DOCTOR IN THE HOSPITAL
THROUGH A PRIVATE APP, MY CHART,
AND THEN I OPEN IT, AND THEN TEN
MINUTES LATER I START GETTING
STUFF ON THE DISEASE I MIGHT
HAVE HAD. THAT IS FRIGHTENING TO
ME. IF THEY'RE I KNOW THEY'RE
DOING IT TO EVERYBODY. SO WHEN
YOU KNOW, WHEN THE CHAMBER COMES
UP AND SAYS, OH, OUR COMPANIES
CARE ABOUT PRIVACY RIGHTS, NO
THEY DON'T. THEY CARE ABOUT
TURNING A PROFIT. AND WE NEED TO
PROTECT OUR KIDS. SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY. ALL
RIGHT. THAT SOUNDS LIKE A
MOTION, THAT IS A MOTION.
SENATOR WILK IS MOVED. THE BILL,
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILK, THANK YOU
FOR WORKING. SO DILIGENTLY ON
THIS, THIS HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGING BILL, AND WE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT OVER THE
SUMMER. SO SOME OF THEM ARE
WICKS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
JUST, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. I APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTNERSHIP, I THINK WE DO HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT A BROADER STRATEGY
AROUND SOME OF THE KNOWLEDGE
STANDARD STUFF, WHICH I KNOW YOU
AND I HAVE DISCUSSED. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON THAT IN
THE FUTURE WITH YOU AS WELL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
PARTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SENATOR. MEMBER WILK HAS MOVED
THE BILL. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CALL.
GENERAL ASSEMBLY MEMBER. HE
DEMOTED ME AGAIN. OH, I'M SORRY,
I DID. I APOLOGIZE. YES,
GOVERNOR WILK HAS MOVED THE BILL
, SO WE'D BE IN MUCH BETTER
SHAPE IF I WERE RIGHT. RIGHT
RIGHT. OKAY. ALL RIGHT, HERE WE
GO. OKAY, MADAM SECRETARY, CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX, AB 1949. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG I
UMBERG. AYE. WILK AYE. WILK. AYE
ALLEN. ASHBY. CABALLERO DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. AYE. LAIRD LAIRD. AYE.
NILA. NILA. AYE ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
STERN WAHAB. 6 TO 0 SIX ZERO.
ALL RIGHT. WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILSON, BACK TO YOU. ITEM NUMBER
FOUR, AB 2319. THANK YOU. CHAIR.
RECOGNIZING YOUR DAY IS LONG. WE
WILL TRY TO MAKE THIS AS QUICK
AS POSSIBLE. ALTHOUGH THIS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND WE'VE
GIVEN OUR WITNESSES, WE'VE NOTED
TO OUR WITNESSES, TO BE AS BRIEF
AS POSSIBLE WHILE GETTING THEIR
POINT ACROSS. I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 2319, A BILL THAT
AIMS TO REDUCE THE ALARMING AND
DISPROPORTIONATE MATERNAL
MORTALITY RATE OF BLACK WOMEN
AND OTHER PREGNANT PERSONS OF
COLOR BY ENSURING SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 464, THE
CALIFORNIA DIGNITY IN PREGNANCY
AND CHILDBIRTH ACT OF 2019, A
RECENT STUDY BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
FOUND THAT WOMEN OF COLOR AND
PARTICULARLY BLACK WOMEN, DIE OF
PREGNANCY RELATED COMPLICATIONS
AT A MUCH HIGHER RATE THAN WHITE
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA. THIS
DISPARITY EXISTS AT ALL INCOME
LEVELS, TO ADDRESS THIS, THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
PASSED THE ACT IN 2019, WHICH
REQUIRES HOSPITALS, ALTERNATIVE
BIRTH CENTERS, AND PRIMARY CARE
CLINICS, WHICH ARE THE
FACILITIES COVERED UNDER THE ACT
TO CONDUCT EVIDENCE BASED
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING FOR ALL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WHO PROVIDE
CARE DURING A PATIENT'S
PREGNANCY, CHILDBIRTH, AND
IMMEDIATE POSTPARTUM PERIOD. IN
AUGUST 2021, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE LAUNCHED AN
INVESTIGATION TO ASCERTAIN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE ACT. WHILE
SOME FACILITIES WENT ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE REQUIREMENTS OF ACT,
THERE IS STILL MORE WORK TO BE
DONE, FOR FULL COMPLIANCE. THE
DOJ INVESTIGATION REVEALED THAT
THERE IS A NEED FOR ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS, PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY
OF COMPLIANCE, DATA FIRM
COMPLIANCE DEADLINES, AND
ADDITIONALLY, SPECIFICITY AND
CLARITY SO THAT FACILITY
FACILITIES ARE BETTER EQUIPPED
TO KNOW WHICH PROVIDERS NEED TO
BE TRAINED. AB 2319 MAKES THE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO ENSURE
WE ARE DOING WHAT WE CAN TO
PROTECT BLACK BIRTHING PEOPLE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WITH ME
TODAY IS TIFFANY BROKAW FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE AND
MONICA WASHINGTON, A MOTHER WHO
HAS UNFORTUNATELY EXPERIENCED
RACIAL BIASES FIRSTHAND AND
WOULD LIKE TO TELL HER STORY.
ALL RIGHT, FIRST, MISS BROKAW,
WE HAVEN'T SEEN YOU IN A WHILE.
GO AHEAD. I'M GLAD THERE WAS A
GAP THERE FROM WHEN YOU SAW ME
LAST. SO, ANYWAY, GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS. TIFFANY
BROKAW, DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL ROB BONTA, WHO IS ONE OF
THE PROUD SPONSORS OF AB 2319,
THE UNITED STATES HAS THE
HIGHEST MATERNAL MORTALITY RATE
IN THE DEVELOPED WORLD AND IN
CALIFORNIA, PEOPLE OF COLOR,
PARTICULARLY BLACK WOMEN,
CONTINUE TO DIE AT 3 TO 4 TIMES
THE RATE OF WHITE WOMEN. SO TO
ADDRESS THIS, THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB 464 IN 2019, AND IT'S
ONE THING FOR A LOT TO BE
PASSED, BUT IT'S ANOTHER TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S IMPLEMENTED
PROPERLY, SO THE DOJ LAUNCHED AN
INVESTIGATION TO ASCERTAIN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE ACT. AND
FROM THAT INVESTIGATION, DOJ
FOUND WAYS TO BETTER EQUIP
HEALTH FACILITIES TO COMPLY WITH
THE LAW. AND THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE REFLECTED IN
AB 2319. AND THEY ARE TO PROVIDE
CLARITY ON WHICH FACILITIES ARE
MANDATED TO ADMINISTER THE
TRAININGS, WHICH EMPLOYEES NEED
TO BE TRAINED, ESTABLISHING FIRM
DEADLINES FOR WHICH TRAININGS
MUST BE COMPLETED, CONFER
ENFORCEMENT POWERS TO THE DOJ,
AND AUTHORIZE THE DOJ TO POST
COMPLIANCE DATA ONLINE SO THE
PUBLIC CAN SEE WHICH FACILITIES
DID OR DID NOT ADMINISTER THESE
TRAININGS. AND FOR THESE
REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHTY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS,
PLEASE. GO AHEAD. YES, I'M
MONICA WASHINGTON. I LIVE IN
SOUTH SACRAMENTO, I'M A MOTHER
OF THREE AND A HOMESCHOOL MOM.
AND WIFE. BLACK WOMEN HAVE 40%
MORE MISCARRIAGES THAN WHITE
WOMEN IN THE US, AND MOST OF
THEM ARE DUE TO TREATABLE
CONDITIONS. THIS STATISTIC
BECAME OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE FOR
ME TO KNOW BECAUSE FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS, I'VE ENDURED FOUR
UNEXPLAINED MISCARRIAGES IN A
ROW WITH NO END IN SIGHT. MY
MOST RECENT ONE WAS IN MARCH. IT
WASN'T UNTIL THIS FOURTH ONE
THAT I FINALLY GET A DIAGNOSIS
CHRONIC ENDOMETRITIS A TREATABLE
BACTERIAL INFECTION OF THE
ENDOMETRIUM KNOWN FOR AT LEAST
THE PAST 25 YEARS TO CAUSE
INFERTILITY AND RECURRENT
MISCARRIAGES. BUT BECAUSE I AM A
BLACK WOMAN AND ALSO OF ADVANCED
MATERNAL AGE, I WAS SELECTIVELY
DENIED THE OPPORTUNITY TO AT
LEAST BE OFFERED THE DIAGNOSTIC
TESTING TO SEE IF CHRONIC
ENDOMETRITIS WAS INDEED THE
CULPRIT FOR ME OF ALL OF THE
SUDDEN, OF ME HAVING SUDDEN
MISCARRIAGES, NOT ONLY AM I A
BLACK WOMAN OF ADVANCED MATERNAL
AGE, BUT I AM ALSO A MEDI-CAL
RECIPIENT, WHICH LEFT ME
VULNERABLE TO INSURANCE BIAS AND
SELECTIVE WITHHOLDING OF CARE.
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. NOT
BECAUSE MY INSURANCE DIDN'T
COVER IT, BUT BECAUSE THE DOCTOR
DIDN'T THINK I WAS DESERVING OF
A CERTAIN KIND OF SCREENING AND
CARE. SO REPEATEDLY, YEAR AFTER
YEAR, DOCTORS WERE GIVING ME THE
BARE MINIMUM BOTTOM OF THE
BARREL OB GYN CARE, AND I KNEW
IT. SO I LITERALLY HOPPED AROUND
FROM ONE OB OB GYN CLINIC AND
HOSPITAL TO ANOTHER, HOPING TO
FIND A DOCTOR WHO WOULDN'T WRITE
ME OFF BECAUSE OF MY SKIN COLOR
AND MY AGE. IN ALL OF MY
EXPERIENCES WITH DIFFERENT
FACILITIES, I HAVE LEARNED THAT
FOR A BLACK WOMAN ON MEDI-CAL
SEEKING OPTIMUM STANDARD OF
CARE, IT DIDN'T MATTER WHAT
FACILITY I WENT TO, BIAS AND
DISCRIMINATION FROM ONE OR
MULTIPLE PEOPLE IN ANY GIVEN
FACILITY ALWAYS FOUND ME. I
EXPERIENCED IT AT SACRAMENTO
COUNTY HEALTH CENTER CAPITAL
OBGYN SUTTER WELL, SPACE HILL,
I'M GOING TO ASK YOU TO WRAP IT
UP, PLEASE. SURE. I DIDN'T
ALMOST DIE IN MY MATERNAL CARE
CRISIS BECAUSE I AM BLACK. I
ALMOST DIED BECAUSE OF HOW A
DOCTOR DECIDED TO TREAT ME
BECAUSE I AM BLACK. I DIDN'T
HAVE FOUR MISCARRIAGES IN A ROW
BECAUSE I AM BLACK. I HAD THEM
BECAUSE OF WITHHOLDING AND
NEGLECT, THE STANDARD OF CARE. I
ASSUME YOU'RE URGING AND I VOTE,
RIGHT? YES SIR. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
THOSE IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. GIVE US
YOUR NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION,
YOUR POSITION. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR. MY NAME IS ONYA MOBILE
WITH BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS
AND BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS
ACTION PROJECT. PROUD
CO-SPONSORS SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
BECCA KRAMER, ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, NORA LYNN. WITH
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, KELLY BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT, THANK
YOU, SYMPHONY BARBIE, ON BEHALF
OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HI. CAROL GONZALEZ, ON
BEHALF OF HOPE HISPANAS
ORGANIZED FOR POLITICAL EQUALITY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JENNIFER
ROBLES WITH HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU, LILY
MACKAY ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA AND FIRST FIVE LÀ ON
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI, KELLY MCMILLAN. ON BEHALF OF
MARCH OF DIMES AND THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS. THANK
YOU, CATHY MCDONALD, FOR THE
COUNTY OF ALAMEDA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, SANDRA POOLE, ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY, PROUD CO-SPONSOR
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. GENESIS GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT,
THANK YOU, CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS, BOTH IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MISS
RUBALCAVA WITH NIELSEN
MERKSAMER. ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. BETH
MALINOWSKI, THE SEIU CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DAWN
CAPC, ON BEHALF OF THE CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION CENTER IN
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RESOURCE
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT PARTY.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED, LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 2319, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NO ONE COMING FORWARD.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATOR ROTH
HAS MOVED THE BILL. SENATOR
NIELLO HAS A QUESTION. SENATOR
WILK HAS A QUESTION. I THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE, A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM. I AGREE, AND SOMETHING
THIS SIGNIFICANT IS RARELY DUE
TO JUST ONE FACTOR. AND AS YOUR
WITNESS POINTED OUT, A
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR IN THE ISSUE
IS MEDI-CAL. RACISM CAN HAVE A
FACTOR, BUT PERHAPS WE'RE
MISSING THE ROLE OF POVERTY THAT
FORCES PEOPLE TO MEDICARE. THAT
RESTRICTS ACCESS SIGNIFICANTLY.
SEEMS TO ME THAT OUGHT TO BE
PART OF THE ISSUE. ALSO IF THIS
BILL PASSES AND, IF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS ENFORCEMENT
RESPONSIBILITIES, I HOPE HE WILL
VIEW HIS RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENFORCE AS BEING LARGER THAN
JUST ONE PARTICULAR TARGET. AND
PERHAPS GO AFTER THE DYSFUNCTION
OF OUR MEDICARE SYSTEM BECAUSE
WE ARE WE UNDER PAY AND
THEREFORE MANY PHYSICIANS DON'T
ACCEPT MEDI-CAL PATIENTS AND
THERE'S A SERIOUS LACK OF ACCESS
THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE IN
THIS PARTICULAR PROBLEM. AND
AGAIN, IF THE BILL PASSES, I
HOPE THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILL RECOGNIZE THAT AND PERHAPS
TRY TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, THROUGH THE
CHAIR. THANK YOU, SENATOR, FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND WHOLLY AGREE
WITH THEM. AND THE, WHAT WE
FOUND FROM THE DOJ'S AUDIT IS
THERE WERE SEVERAL ISSUES THAT
LED TO THE THIS THE ALARMING
RATES, RELATED TO BLACK,
MATERNAL HEALTH, AND A LESS
SUCCESSFUL OUTCOME. AND IT IS
ACROSS ALL INCOME LEVELS. AND SO
WE AS THE BLACK CAUCUS, WHEN
HEARING UPON THAT, HAVE SET OUT
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE WITH
MULTIPLE BILLS. THIS IS THE
FIRST OF MANY THAT YOU WILL SEE
RELATED TO THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE. BASED ON THAT AUDIT. AND
SO WE WILL ADDRESS ALL OF THE
ISSUES THAT CAME FORTH, BUT THIS
WAS ONE OF THEM THAT, HAVING GOT
IT HALFWAY THROUGH THE SESSION,
WE FELT LIKE COULD IS A GREAT
START, BECAUSE WE FELT LIKE IT
WAS LOW HANGING FRUIT FOR THE
IMPLICIT BIAS, RECOGNIZING THAT
HOSPITALS WANTED TO DO IT, WERE
DOING IT, BUT THERE WASN'T
CLARITY AROUND IT. AND SO WE
THOUGHT THAT WAS EASIER TO START
WITH. AND THEN THE REST ARE A
BIT MORE COMPLEX. AND THEY WILL
BE BEFORE YOU, IN THE NEW
SESSION, I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANYTHING COMPLEX AT ALL ABOUT
THE PROBLEMS WITH MEDICARE UNDER
REIMBURSEMENT AND LACK OF ACCESS
, AND I REALLY WISH THAT YOU
WOULD HAVE INCLUDED THAT ASPECT
IN YOUR BILL. AND WHEN I MEAN
COMPLEX, I MEAN, WRITING THE LAW
CAN GET A LITTLE HAIRY
SOMETIMES. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SENATOR WILK, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, I'M. I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. I
CONCUR WITH MY COLLEAGUE THAT
IT'S MORE COMPREHENSIVE, BUT IN
L.A. COUNTY, THEY DO A HEALTH
CARE ASSESSMENT EVERY THREE
YEARS, AND IT'S BROKEN DOWN BY
SERVICE PROVIDER AREA SPAS AND
THE ANTELOPE VALLEY, WHICH IS IN
MY DISTRICT IS SPA NUMBER ONE.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THOSE HEALTH
OUTCOMES, THEY ARE HORRIBLE. BUT
WHEN IT RELATES TO BLACK WOMEN
AND BLACK INFANT MORTALITY, IT'S
ON PAR WITH THE THIRD WORLD
COUNTRY. SO THERE'S THINGS GOING
ON. SO I THINK WE AGAIN A
HOLISTIC APPROACH BUT HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR PROPOSAL TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. DR. RUSSELL,
THANK YOU. I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR VERY MUCH. AND OUR
WITNESS FOR BEING HERE AND
EVERYONE WHO'S WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOT
ONLY ON BEHALF OF BLACK WOMEN,
BUT HOW THAT IMPACT ALSO ON
OTHER WOMEN OF COLOR, IMMIGRANTS
, IMMIGRANT WOMEN, SO WHAT
YOU'RE DOING IS HELPING ALL
WOMEN WHO FACE THAT, FACE THAT
BIAS, WHO FACE THAT RACISM, FACE
THAT DISCRIMINATION, AND WE'VE
WE'VE GONE THROUGH THIS IN PAST
DECADES, BUT IT NEVER SEEMS TO
STOP. AND I'M PROUD THAT YOU'RE
OFFERING PARTIAL SOLUTION TO
THAT. BUT WE CAN GO BACK JUST A
FEW DECADES TO WHEN WE WERE
FORCIBLY STERILIZED WHEN, YOU
KNOW, JUST OUTRAGEOUS THINGS
LIKE THAT HAPPENING, STEMMING
FROM THE RACISM TOWARDS,
ESPECIALLY WOMEN OF COLOR AND
BLACK WOMEN. SO THANK YOU FOR
DOING THIS. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, I THINK SENATOR ROTH
HAS MOVED THE BILL, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, I JUST WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THANK YOU TO MY WITNESSES FOR
BEING HERE, ESPECIALLY TO THE
MOTHER WHO SHARED HER LIVED
EXPERIENCE. THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION. THIS IS NOT THE LAST
TIME YOU'LL SEE ME TALKING ABOUT
THIS ISSUE. IT IS BIG AND NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED TO ENSURE THAT
ALL WOMEN, ALL BIRTHING PEOPLE,
WHEN THEY HAVE A PREGNANCY, THAT
THERE IS A SUCCESSFUL OUTCOME
FOR THEM AND THEIR BABY, AND
WITH. THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR ROTH.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOR AB 2319. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
UMBERG Ã UMBERG. AYE WILK. AYE.
WILK. AYE. ALLEN ASHBY.
CABALLERO. DURAZO GRASSO. AYE.
LAIRD LAIRD. AYE. NEELO. NO
NEELO. NO. ROTH. ROTH AYE.
STERN. WAHAB 5 TO 1 FIVE ONE.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL. ALL
RIGHT. FILE NUMBER FIVE, AB
3138. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. SENATORS, I WANT TO START
BY THANKING THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY. WITH MY OFFICE ON
AMENDS, ALTHOUGH WE'RE
CONTINUING THOSE NEGOTIATIONS.
WE WILL TAKE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDS, WHICH INCLUDES A TWO
YEAR DELAY IN IMPLEMENTATION,
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE CHAIR IS
OPEN TO CONTINUE OUR DISCUSSION
ON THE APPROPRIATE AMENDS, AS
WELL AS RECOGNIZING THERE IS NOT
A DESIRE TO RESTRICT CURRENT
PROTECTIONS UNDER LAW FOR FLEET
OPERATORS, COMMERCIAL CARS OR
CARS WITH OCCUPATIONAL LICENSES,
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 3138,
WHICH WILL ALLOW, MODIFICATION
OF THE EXISTING ALTERNATIVE
DIGITAL LICENSE PLATE PROGRAM,
TO ALLOW DRIVERS THE OPTION TO
INCLUDE VEHICLE LOCATION
TECHNOLOGY MORE COMMONLY KNOWN
AS GPS. WITH THE AMENDMENTS,
THIS BILL WILL ALSO SUBJECT THE
DIGITAL PLATES TO APPROVAL BY
BOTH THE DMV AND CHP, AND WILL
REQUIRE DMV TO CONDUCT ANALYSIS
OF BANNER MESSAGES DISPLAYED ON
LICENSE PLATE. THIS BUILDS UPON
A SUCCESSFUL PILOT PROGRAM
LAUNCHED OVER A DECADE AGO. IN
2013, A 2019 REPORT BY DMV
ASSESSING THE ALTERNATIVE DEVICE
PILOT PROGRAM, WHICH NOTABLY
ALLOWED FOR GPS AND BANNER
MESSAGES, IT FOUND THAT NO
SIGNIFICANT LAW ENFORCEMENT, DMV
OR CUSTOMER CONCERNS IF THIS
BILL BECOMES LAW, ALL DRIVERS
WILL STILL BE ABLE TO RECEIVE
THE METAL LICENSE PLATES THAT
THEY ARE ACCUSTOMED TO SEEING,
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THAT,
BUT IT GIVES DRIVERS A CHOICE
WHETHER THEY WOULD LIKE AN
ALTERNATIVE DEVICE THAT HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE DMV AND CHP. AN
OPTION THAT HAS EXISTED FOR
YEARS UNDER THE PILOT PROGRAM.
THIS BILL ALSO PUTS IN PLACE
PRIVACY STANDARDS FOR GPS PLATES
THAT FAR EXCEED PROTECTIONS IN
CURRENT LAW. FOR OTHER
COMPARABLE GPS EQUIPPED DEVICES,
SUCH AS THE CARS THEMSELVES.
APPS USED INSIDE THE CARS OR
CELL PHONES, AND COUNTLESS OTHER
LEGAL PRODUCTS AVAILABLE TO
CONSUMERS AT MUCH CHEAPER
PRICES. AB 3138 REQUIRES THE
FOLLOWING PROTECTIONS FOR GPS
ENABLED PLATES SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA. THE GPS MUST BE
CAPABLE OF BEING PERMANENTLY
DISABLED BY MEANS OF A
NONREVERSIBLE METHOD THAT CEASES
ALL FUNCTIONALITY AND TRACKING
INFORMATION. CAPABILITIES. THE
GPS SHALL BE CAPABLE OF BEING
MANUALLY DISABLED AND ENABLED BY
A DRIVER OF THE VEHICLE, WHILE
THAT VEHICLE WHILE THAT DRIVER
IS INSIDE THE VEHICLE, THE
METHOD OF MANUALLY DISABLING AND
ENABLING THE GPS SHALL BE
PERMANENTLY LOCATED AND EASY TO
DISABLE AND ENABLE WITHOUT
REQUIRING ACCESS TO A REMOTE
ONLINE APPLICATION. THE METHOD
OF MANUALLY DISABLING AND
ENABLING THE GPS SHALL NOT
REQUIRE A PASSWORD OR ANY LOGIN
INFORMATION. AND FINALLY, ONCE
THE VEHICLE LOCATION TECHNOLOGY
IS MANUALLY DISABLED FROM INSIDE
THE CAR, THE ONLY METHOD OF
RE-ENABLING THE TECHNOLOGY SHALL
BE MANUAL FROM INSIDE THE CAR.
THE REGISTERED OWNER OF THE
LICENSE PLATE, THE MANUFACTURER,
THE DMV OR ANY OTHER ENTITY
SHALL NOT HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO
REENGAGE THE GPS THROUGH ANY
REMOTE MEANS. WITH ME TODAY IS
TO PRESENT AND SUPPORT. I HAVE
ESTEBAN NUNEZ ON BEHALF OF
REVIVER. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS JUAN NUNEZ. I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF REVIVER. AS THE AUTHOR
STATED, WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS, AND
REVIVER REMAINS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH STAFF AND MEMBERS
TO GET THIS BILL IN A
COMFORTABLE PLACE FOR EVERYBODY.
AB 3138 REALLY BUILDS OFF THE
WORK THAT HAS THAT. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PREVIOUSLY VOTED
ON, EVEN STARTING WITH SB 806,
IN 2013. THIS BILL CLARIFIES
THAT DIGITAL LICENSE PLATES MUST
COMPLY WITH PROVISIONS TO ENSURE
THE PRIVACY OF THE CONSUMER IS
NOT COMPROMISED, WHILE
CONTINUING TO STRENGTHEN THE
BENEFITS PROVIDED TO BUSINESSES.
TO BE CLEAR, THERE ARE TWO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PLATES
OFFERED BY REVIVER. THERE IS A
BATTERY OPERATED PLATE WHICH
DOES NOT CONTAIN GPS, AND THERE
IS A WIRED PLATE THAT DOES HAVE
GPS, SO CUSTOMERS HAVE TO
ACTIVELY OPT IN TO HAVING THE
GPS. AND THE GPS IS ALSO AN
EXTRA COST AND A SERVICE THAT'S
PROVIDED BY THE COMPANY. SO TWO
DIFFERENT OPT IN OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE CUSTOMER. ALL REVIVER
SERVICES ARE OPT IN, AND THIS
BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THAT. THIS
BILL WILL HELP TO MAINTAIN
CUSTOMER SAFETY AND PRIVACY
RIGHTS BY STRENGTHENING THE
PARAMETERS AROUND GEOLOCATION
TECHNOLOGY, WHICH WE HOPE CAN BE
APPLIED MORE BROADLY LATER ON.
THE LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL
CLEARLY STATES THAT THE
ALTERNATIVE, IF THE ALTERNATIVE
DEVICES FAIL TO MEET THESE
REQUIREMENTS, VEHICLE LOCATION
TECHNOLOGY SHALL NOT BE
PERMITTED IN THE DEVICES AS AB
984, THE PREVIOUS LEGISLATION
THAT FORMALIZED THE PILOT
PROGRAM, MOVED THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE. LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
. IN 2022, AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN
AS A RESULT OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS, WITH OPPOSITION
TO INCLUDE A KILL SWITCH
MECHANISM, THE NONREVERSIBLE
MECHANISM THAT THE AUTHOR JUST
STATED, DIGITAL LICENSE PLATES
AND GEOLOCATION TECHNOLOGY HAS
HAD MANY BENEFITS TO FLEET
VEHICLES AND SMALL BUSINESSES.
WE HAVE HAD MANY SUPPORT LETTERS
AND TESTIMONIALS FROM OUR USERS
AND CUSTOMERS THAT PROVE
REVIVERS MODERNIZATION AND BATCH
REGISTRATION RENEWAL PROCESS
PROMOTES ACCOUNTABILITY AND
EFFICIENCY FOR THEIR FOR THEIR
CUSTOMERS AND THEIR STAFF. THANK
YOU. PARTY. THANK YOU, MISS
NUNEZ. ALL RIGHT. ANYONE ELSE
WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF AB 3138,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
GOOD MORNING, ANTHONY SAMPSON,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NEW
CAR DEALERS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH. SEEING NO ONE ELSE,
LET'S TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 3138,
PLEASE APPROACH EITHER THE TABLE
OR THE MICROPHONE. YOUR CHOICE.
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR, WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON, YOU'VE I
SEE MEMBERS ARE LOOKING THROUGH
THEIR ANALYSIS. THE AMENDMENT
THAT YOU DISCUSSED IS NOT IN THE
ANALYSIS. THAT'S A TWO YEAR
DELAY IN IMPLEMENTATION. SO YOU
NEED NOT LOOK THROUGH THE
ANALYSIS. YOU'VE ACCEPTED THAT
AMENDMENT. AND I UNDERSTAND
BECAUSE I WAS PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION. YOU PROPOSED OTHER
AMENDMENTS LATE LAST NIGHT, THAT
WE HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO SEE
OR ANALYZE. I HAVEN'T REJECTED
THEM, NOR HAS THE COMMITTEE
REJECTED THEM. AND YOU'RE FREE
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION AND APPROPRIATIONS.
BUT JUST I WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE RECORD WAS CLEAR ON
THAT SCORE. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. IS THAT YOUR UNDERSTANDING
ALSO? THAT IS MY UNDERSTANDING.
THANK YOU. CHAIR. THANK YOU.
LET'S NOW TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. BECCA KRAMER, MATTER
ON BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION,
AB 3138 PUTS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS AND LGBTQ TEENS AT
RISK. IT ALLOWS GPS SURVEILLANCE
TRACKERS AND LICENSE PLATES,
WHICH CAN BE USED BY
UNSUPPORTIVE PARENTS TO SEE, FOR
EXAMPLE, IF THEIR TEEN HAS GONE
TO THE LOCAL LGBTQ CENTER OR BY
ABUSERS TO TRACK DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS WHO MAY STILL
LIVE WITH THEM. AB 3138
UNDERMINES CALIFORNIA'S STATUS
AS A REFUGE FOR PEOPLE SEEKING
ABORTIONS. A PASSENGER IN A LYFT
CAR OR A FRIEND'S VEHICLE WHO
GETS PICKED UP AT THE AIRPORT
AND TAKEN DIRECTLY TO PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, MAY NOT KNOW THAT
THE CAR THEY'RE IN HAS A TRACKER
THAT COULD PROVIDE EVIDENCE
AGAINST THEM. IN A CASE ABOUT
TRAVELING HERE FOR AN ABORTION
AGAINST THEIR STATE'S ANTI
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE LAWS, AB
3138 PROVIDES ICE THE ABILITY TO
LOCATE UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS
THROUGH GPS SURVEILLANCE
TECHNOLOGY. THIS IS WHY MANY
LGBTQ REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ORGANIZATIONS
OPPOSE THE 2022 BILL THAT MADE
PERMANENT THE DIGITAL LICENSE
PLATE PROGRAM, UNTIL THAT BILL
WAS AMENDED TO PROHIBIT GPS
TRACKERS AND DIGITAL LICENSE
PLATES ON PASSENGER VEHICLES. AB
3138 WOULD REMOVE THAT SAFETY
PROTECTION, INSTEAD INSERTING
BACK IN LANGUAGE LIKE THAT WHICH
THESE ORGANIZATIONS HAVE. IF
YOU'D WRAP IT UP, I ASSUME
YOU'RE URGING A NO VOTE. I'M
URGING A NO VOTE BECAUSE THIS
LANGUAGE DOES NOT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT POWER DYNAMICS, WHICH IS
WHY THE OPPOSITION REJECTED IT
ORIGINALLY. THANK YOU. OKAY,
TRACY ROSENBERG WITH OAKLAND
PRIVACY. GOOD MORNING, IN APRIL
OF 2023, ONLY 90 DAYS AFTER AB
984, THE ORIGINAL ENABLING
LEGISLATION WENT INTO EFFECT.
REVIVER THE ONLY APPROVED VENDOR
FOR THESE PROJECTS, SUFFERED A
CATASTROPHIC SECURITY CRISIS
WHERE HACKERS WERE ABLE TO GAIN
MASTER ACCESS TO THE CENTRAL
DATABASE. THEY COULD REPORT
CARDS WITH STOLEN WHEN THEY
WEREN'T, DELETE LICENSE PLATES.
YOUR LICENSE PLATE FOR EXAMPLE,
AND SEE ALL THE GPS DATA FOR THE
30,000 PILOT VEHICLES WITH GPS
THAT WERE ON THE ROAD TO ADD A
MASSIVE COLLECTION OF HIGHLY
SENSITIVE GEOLOCATION DATA TO A
COMPANY THAT HAS ALREADY
EXPERIENCED A SEVERE BREACH OF
SECURITY, IS ILL ADVISED, AND
CANNOT RESPONSIBLE. THIS SHOULD
NOT BE A BUYER BEWARE SITUATION.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO DMV AND
BEING TOLD THIS IS A SAFE AND
SECURE PRODUCT. WHEN THE
EVIDENCE IS THAT IT'S THAT IT IS
NOT. AND THAT WAS LESS THAN A
YEAR AGO. POLLS SHOW THAT PEOPLE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT WHERE THE
DATA TAKEN BY THEIR CARS ENDS
UP, AND THE NEXT TIME A RIVER OF
CALIFORNIANS GEOLOCATION DATA
ENDS UP FOR SALE TO THE HIGHEST
BIDDER, PEOPLE WILL NOT BE
HAPPY. THE 2022 AGREEMENT IN AB
984 THAT WAS CRAFTED IN THE
SENATE WAS BALANCED. IT OPENED
UP A NEW PRODUCT, WHILE AVOIDING
FORESEEABLE HARMS TO
CALIFORNIANS IN SENATE
TRANSPORTATION. THE COMPANY
ITSELF. THE SPOKESPERSON SAID
THERE WAS NO HEAVY DEMAND FOR
THE PRODUCT FOR RESIDENTIAL
VEHICLES, THEREFORE, AND WE JUST
HEARD ABOUT THE AMENDMENT. RIGHT
NOW, WE THINK THE AB 984
AGREEMENT IN 2022 WAS THE RIGHT
THING, AND IT SHOULD STAY IN
PLACE. THANKS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION TO AB
3138, PLEASE APPROACH. HELLO,
DANNY. CANDLE KAISER, ON BEHALF
OF THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION, PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. SEE NO
ONE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING NO
QUESTIONS. SENATOR. ALSO SORRY.
ON SUCH A BUSY DAY, BUT A LOT OF
QUESTIONS. I'M, I'M VERY MIXED
ABOUT THIS, THE ISSUES OF
PRIVACY ARE VERY SERIOUS, WE
KNOW IN OUR LIFE EXPERIENCES HOW
IMPORTANT THE ISSUES HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT UP, ABOUT PRIVACY. AND
I'M A LITTLE. THIS IS THIS IS
THE INCLUSION NOW OF A PRIVATE,
PRIVATE SECTOR COMPANY AND
CONNECTED WITH THE DMV. A
GOVERNMENT COMPANY. AND I'M A
LITTLE CONFUSED AS TO THE ACCESS
AND THE CONNECTION THAT THE
THREE HAVE WITH EACH OTHER. IT'S
NOT. I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
EXAMPLES HAVE BEEN GIVEN BY THE
OPPOSITION OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OR BEING UNDOCUMENTED, BUT
PUTTING THOSE ASIDE, IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE WE'VE OPENED UP THE
POSSIBILITY FOR ANYBODY WHO'S
EVEN IF THEY'RE AWARE THAT THEY
HAVE THE GPS, IT JUST OPENS UP
THE POSSIBILITY WHERE DOES THAT
WHERE DOES THAT INFORMATION GO?
WHERE IS THE TRACKING DONE, BY
WHOM? AND IS IT JUST IN THE
CONTROL OF THE OWNER OF THE
VEHICLE? OR IS IT AGAIN, NOW
THAT WE HAVE PRIVATE, YOU KNOW,
SECTOR INVOLVEMENT, IT'S GETTING
ALL CONFUSED HERE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION AND
YOUR CONCERN AND PRIVACY IS OF
UTMOST IMPORTANCE TO ME. AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I EXPRESS
REGULARLY AS I SIT ON THE
PRIVACY COMMITTEE ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE, AND SO THIS BILL,
BUILDS UPON WHAT IS ALREADY
EXISTING LAW WHERE WE DO HAVE A
PRIVATE SECTOR INVOLVEMENT IN
OUR DMV REGISTRATION PROCESS.
AND THE PLATES ITSELF ARE DUMB
PLATES, MEANING THAT THERE IS NO
INFORMATION CONTAINED IN THE
PLATES. JUST THE NUMBER, THE
LICENSE PLATE NUMBER AND THE
VEHICLE IDENTIFICATION NUMBER.
AND SO THAT IS ALL SOMEONE CAN
ACCESS FROM THE PLATES. THE
QUESTION IS, IS THE GPS ENABLED
TECHNOLOGY? WHERE DOES THAT LIVE
THAT LIVES WITHIN THE APP AND
COMPLETELY OWNED BY THE USER.
IT'S NOT OWNED BY THE COMPANY IN
ANY WAY, SHAPE OR FORM, THE HACK
THAT WAS TALKED ABOUT WAS THE
WHITE HAT. RESEARCHERS IN 2022
HACKED NOT ONLY, REVIVER, BUT A
NUMBER OF CAR MANUFACTURERS AS
WELL TO SHOW THE
VULNERABILITIES. AND OF COURSE,
WHEN THOSE VULNERABILITIES WERE
SHOWN, THEN THOSE ISSUES WERE
RESOLVED NOT ONLY WITH REVIVER,
BUT WITH THE CAR MANUFACTURERS
AS WELL. AND SO THAT WAS AN
INTENTIONAL DONE BY RESEARCHERS,
NOT HACKERS ON THE DARK WEB.
THAT INFORMATION THAT WAS HACKED
DOES NOT LIVE ANYWHERE ON THE
DARK WEB, BECAUSE IT WAS DONE
INTENTIONALLY BY RESEARCHERS,
AND SO I WOULD SAY THAT THE
INFORMATION IS PRIVATE. THERE
HAS BEEN BOLSTERING OF
TECHNOLOGY AND AS WE KNOW, AS
TECHNOLOGY GROWS AND ADVANCES,
THERE ARE ALL VULNERABILITIES
THAT EXIST. AND THAT'S WHY YOU
CONTINUALLY HAVE IMPROVEMENT ON
THEM. TO BE ABLE TO ASSURE THOSE
UP. BUT ONCE AGAIN, THE PLATES
THEMSELVES ARE DUMB. IF SOMEBODY
WAS TO ACCESS THE PLATE, THEY
WOULD GET SOMEONE'S LICENSE,
NUMBER AND THEY WOULD GET
SOMEONE'S VEHICLE IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER. THINGS THAT YOU CAN GET
FROM A METAL PLATE NOW AND
WALKING UP TO SOMEONE'S WINDOW,
AND SEEING ON THEIR WINDOW WE
KNOW OUR VEHICLE IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER IS LISTED IN SEVERAL
PLACES OF CAR AND IS ACTUALLY
VISIBLE. YOU KNOW, FROM, IF YOU
WALK UP TO A FRONT WINDOW. SO
THOSE ARE THE TWO THINGS THAT
SOMEONE CAN ACCESS FROM A PLATE,
AND SO I JUST WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT THOSE PROTECTIONS EXIST.
JUST ONE MORE, ONE MORE
QUESTION, IS INFORMATION ON THE
THAT'S GATHERED OR, TRACKED BY
THE GPS? IS THAT STORED, BY THE
COMPANY? IS THAT. YEAH. BUT DOES
A COMPANY HAVE ACCESS TO STORE
THE INFORMATION THAT THE GPS HAS
RECORDED OR. YES, IT'S STORED AS
I UNDERSTAND IT, IT'S STORED IN
THE CLOUD. RIGHT. AND SO IT IS,
BUT IT IS FOR THE USE OF THE
INDIVIDUAL, NOT THE COMPANY, BUT
THE COMPANY IS IN CONTROL OF, OF
THAT INFORMATION. THE COMPANY IS
IN CHARGE OF STORING THAT
INFORMATION ON BEHALF OF THEIR
CONSUMER. THEY ARE NOT IN
CONTROL, MEANING THEY DON'T GET
TO USE IT FOR ANY OTHER PURPOSE,
FOR ANY PURPOSE. THEY ONLY ARE.
AND THIS IS THROUGH DMV REGS. SO
THEY IT IS IT IS OWNED BY THE
USER. AND SO IT IS STORED ON THE
COMPANY'S SERVERS SLASH CLOUD
YOU KNOW. BUT IT IS NOT FOR USE
BY THE COMPANY IN ANY WAY SHAPE
OR FORM. OKAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR STERN MOVED BEALL. ALL
RIGHT. SENATOR LAIRD, JUST
QUICKLY, I THINK THERE'S STILL
CONCERNS. AND I WAS THINKING
THAT THE AMENDMENT MIGHT BE TO
START TO ADDRESS WHAT SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS ARE, OR
GUARDRAILS ABOUT PRIVACY TO THE
EXTENT THEY DON'T ALREADY EXIST.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE THE AMENDMENT
IS TO DELAY THE IMPLEMENTATION
FOR TWO YEARS. SO DOES THAT MEAN
THAT IF THERE ARE STILL
CONCERNS, YOU INTEND TO WORK ON
THEM IN THAT PERIOD? SO THERE
THERE ARE AMENDMENTS TAKING AND
THE ASSEMBLY HOUSE DEALING WITH
THE, THE GUARDRAILS OF PRIVACY.
AND SO WE ADDED ADDITIONAL
AMENDS RELATED TO THAT. THERE
ARE AMENDS THAT THE COMPANY HAS
PROPOSED. THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO
THOSE LEGISLATIVELY. THEY CAN DO
THOSE WITH DMV THROUGH THE
APPROVAL PROCESS, BUT THEY CAN
BE DONE LEGISLATIVELY IF THAT'S
THE WILL OF THE BODY, THEY AMEND
THAT THE CHAIR OFFERED WAS A TWO
YEAR DELAY TO GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUTSIDE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS, GIVEN THE
FACT THAT IT WAS TWO YEARS FRESH
OR TWO YEARS FRESH FROM THE
WHITE HAT RESEARCHERS HACK OF
ALL, VEHICLES, TO BE ABLE TO
THEN CONTINUE STRENGTHEN, THE
GUARDRAILS AROUND TECHNOLOGY,
OUTSIDE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS, JUST THE NATURAL
OCCURRENCE OF WHAT BUSINESSES
DO. AND THAT'S HOW I UNDERSTAND
THE TWO YEAR IMPLEMENTATION. THE
DELAY OF THE TWO YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION OF WORK WAS AT
THE CHAIR'S. YES. YOU'RE
CORRECT. OKAY YES. SO THAT'S HOW
THAT WAS NODDING FOR INITIALLY
FOR THOSE OF YOU AT HOME OKAY,
OKAY. I MEAN, BECAUSE I WAS
QUEASY ABOUT THIS AND SHARE SOME
OF THE CONCERNS AND, DON'T KNOW,
AND I'M A LAY PERSON, BUT WHEN
IT'S LIKE, OH, THE COMPANY IS
JUST RESPONSIBLE FOR STORING IT,
THEY STILL HAVE ACCESS TO IT.
THEY DO HAVE ACCESS TO IT, BUT
THEY ARE NOT. IT IS WHOLLY OWNED
BY THE USER AND SO IT WELL,
WE'VE SEEN VARIOUS HACKS OF
INFORMATION WHOLLY OWNED BY THE
USER. NO, ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. AND
THERE WERE IN 2022, THE WHITE
HAT SEARCHERS SAW THAT THERE WAS
VULNERABILITY AND INFORMATION.
THAT IS STORED, WHICH IS WHICH
LED TO THE UPDATE OF NOT ONLY
THESE POLICIES, BUT RELATED TO
THE VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS.
RIGHT. AS IT RELATES TO THEIR
GPS TECHNOLOGY. BUT I THINK
THAT, YOU KNOW, AND I UNDERSTAND
THE CONCERN BECAUSE THIS CAME UP
LAST SESSION WHEN I WAS WORKING
ON THIS BILL, OF OUR DV
COMMUNITY AND LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
I'M SENSITIVE TO BOTH THOSE
COMMUNITIES FOR VARIOUS REASONS.
WOULD NOT WANT SOMEONE TO FEEL
TRACKED. I HAVE FOUGHT TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA A REFUGE TO CONTINUE
TO BUILD ON WHAT OTHERS HAVE
DONE BEFORE ME. AND SO THERE IS
NO WAY SHAPE OR FORM THAT I
WOULD NOT WANT CALIFORNIA TO BE
A REFUGE. BUT TO SAY THAT,
G.P.S. TECHNOLOGY DOESN'T EXIST
IN A TILE AND AN APPLE POD OR
NOT. APPLE POD, APPLE, AIRTAG.
RIGHT? WE TRACK OUR OUR OUR
SUITCASES NOW, RIGHT? BECAUSE WE
HAVE THAT TECHNOLOGY. THERE ARE
CHEAPER WAYS TO TRACK A VEHICLE.
AND WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING MORE
THAN WHAT IS FOR OTHER GPS
ENABLED VEHICLES RELATED TO THIS
MEANING, WHEN YOU GET INTO A CAR
THAT HAS AN ALTERNATIVE DEVICE,
NOT JUST REVIVER, BUT ANYWHERE
ELSE, AND THERE ARE OTHER
APPLICANTS WHO ARE GOING THROUGH
THIS PROCESS NOW TO GET THEIR
DEVICE APPROVED. IT YOU IT TELLS
YOU THAT YOU HAVE YOUR THAT THIS
VEHICLE IS BEING TRACKED THROUGH
THIS REVIVER PLATE, DOESN'T TELL
YOU WHETHER THERE'S A TAG IN THE
CAR OR A, YOU KNOW, OR OTHER
TYPES OF GPS ENABLED. YOU CAN
DISABLE IT AS A DRIVER OUTSIDE
OF THE APP, AND YOU CAN, AND IT
CAN'T BE RE-ENABLED UNLESS IT'S
MANUALLY RE-ENABLED. SO THERE
ARE LOTS OF PROTECTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT VEHICLES ARE NOT
TRACKED. I THINK THE WORST THING
IN POLITICS IS, IS SEMI
REVISIONIST HISTORY OF SOMETHING
GOING WRONG LATER AND EVERYBODY
SAYING I KNEW IT, I KNEW IT AND
YET THERE'S JUST UNEASINESS
ABOUT THIS. I WILL VOTE TO MOVE
IT. BUT IT IT JUST SEEMS THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE VIGILANCE
DURING THAT PERIOD OF TIME TO
SEE IF THERE'S THINGS THAT WE
HAVE NOT CONTEMPLATED ABOUT THIS
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
ABSOLUTELY. AND THAT CAN HAPPEN
AT THE DEPARTMENT LEVEL. THANK
YOU. SENATOR LAIRD. SENATOR
BARRASSO, JUST A QUICK I, I AM
VERY STILL, UNCONVINCED OF ALL
THE ISSUES I WILL SUPPORT JUST
TODAY, BUT I NEED TO SPEND MORE
TIME WITH YOU BECAUSE I'M VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE. OKAY. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT, SENATOR STERN HAS
MOVED THE BILL. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? OKAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THE ROBUST DISCUSSION ON
THIS. AND I UNDERSTAND, YOU KNOW
, THAT IT'S ALWAYS CAN BE QUEASY
WHEN WE'RE CONSIDERING
TECHNOLOGY, BECAUSE IT MOVES
MUCH FASTER THAN THE LAW CAN
KEEP UP. JUST NOTING THAT THE
BILL DOES INCLUDE THAT THE
LANGUAGE THAT THE DATA CANNOT BE
SHARED, AND THAT IS A PROTECTION
WITHIN THE LAW, ALSO NOTING
THAT, I APPRECIATE THE CHAIR
WILLINGNESS AS WELL AS COMMITTEE
STAFF WHO HAS WORKED DILIGENTLY
ON THIS, TO COME UP WITH THE
AMENDS THAT WE WERE ABLE TO GET
ALREADY IN PRINT. PLUS, THE
ADDITIONAL AND THE CONTINUED
DISCUSSION, WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MOVED BY, SENATOR STERN,
MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS THIS IS AB
3138 WITH, SORRY FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG UMBERG I
WILK WILK. I ALLEN ASHBY.
CABALLERO. DURAZO DURAZO I
LAIRD. LAIRD I NILO NILO I ROTH.
ROTH I STERN. STERN I. WAHAB.
YOU HAVE 7 TO 0, SO FAR WITH
MEMBERS MISSING SEVEN ZERO. PUT
THAT ON CALL. ALL RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO FILE NUMBER
11 AB 2460. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. AB
2460 IS A CLEANUP BILL TO MY AB
1458 PASSED BY THIS COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR AND SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR. THIS BILL ADD MINOR
RATIFICATION LANGUAGE REQUESTS
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE. AND
WE AGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO CLEAN UP THIS YEAR.
THIS BILL ALSO CLARIFY THAT THE
ASSOCIATION MEMBERSHIP MAY
RECONVENE AN ELECTION MEETING
USING THE REDUCED QUORUM. IT IS
NOT UP TO THE BOARD. THIS IS
CRITICAL, AS I HAVE LEARNED THAT
SEVERAL SO BOARD HAVE REFUSED TO
RECOGNIZE THE NEW LAW. QUORUM
THRESHOLD OUT FEAR OF BEING
UNSEATED WHEN THE VOTES ARE
TALLIED. WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
INTEGRITY OF THE VOTING PROCESS
IS IN THE HANDS OF THE
ASSOCIATION MEMBERSHIP. TO
GUARANTEE THE CAST VOTES ARE
COUNTED. TODAY, I HAVE WITH
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS,
INSTITUTE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. BROWN, CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, LOUIS BROWN, HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE,
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE ACTION
COMMITTEE, WE BROUGHT THIS BILL
FORWARD AT THE REQUEST OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FROM AB 1458
LAST YEAR TO PROVIDE A
CLARIFICATION ON A RECONVENED
MEETING RATHER THAN A SUBSEQUENT
MEETING, IN DOING SO, WE ALSO
THEN NOTICED THAT THE
DEFINITIONS OF REDUCED QUORUM
WERE DIFFERENT IN THE BILL. SO
WE'VE CLEANED THAT UP, YOU WILL
HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION
REQUESTING THAT WE ACTUALLY
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF INDIVIDUAL
NOTICE ON THIS BILL. THAT WAS AN
ISSUE THAT WE DEBATED LAST YEAR
IN THIS COMMITTEE, ON AB 1458.
AND THIS COMMITTEE VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO KEEP THE BILL AT
GENERAL NOTICE. AND SO WE'VE NOT
ADDRESSED THAT ISSUE PRIMARILY
BECAUSE THE MAIN REASON WE'RE
BACK HERE TODAY IS BECAUSE THE
REQUEST OF THE GOVERNOR, WE ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
ARNIE, THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
BROWN, OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
2460, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHING, LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED,
AB 2460, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HERE WE GO. OKAY, SIR. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS TOM,
SIR. I'M ON THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE OF THE CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA. HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION LAW, AND WE CONTINUE
TO ADVOCATE FOR ARE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
OFFERING THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS, BECAUSE WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THIS BILL IS
IT'S, CLARIFYING SOME WORDING IN
THE UNDERLYING BILL THAT WE
OPPOSED. IT PASSED. WE ACCEPT
THE CURRENT LAW AND APPEAR TODAY
TO OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED,
BECAUSE THE POSTURE, IN THIS
POSTURE, BECAUSE THIS NEW
PROCEDURE FOR LOWERING A QUORUM
NEEDS FURTHER IMPROVEMENTS TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS AND INTERESTS
OF INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS, WHICH
IS OUR CONSTITUENCY. WE'VE
OFFERED AMENDMENTS THAT, FIRST
OF ALL, PROVIDE EXPANDED NOTICE,
AS, MR. BROWN HAS INDICATED OF
THE RECONVENED MEETING AS A
MATTER OF DUE PROCESS, THAT IS
NOTICE. AND BECAUSE SUCH
EXPANDED NOTICE WILL ACTUALLY
IMPROVE VOTER PARTICIPATION.
VOTERS CAN'T VOTE IF THEY DON'T
KNOW AN ELECTION'S BEING
EXTENDED. SECONDLY, THE CURRENT
LAW IN THIS BILL LEAVES
UNANSWERED A CRITICAL QUESTION
OF WHAT HAPPENS TO BALLOTS IF A
QUORUM IS NOT MET. THESE BALLOTS
SHOULD REMAIN UNOPENED AND
UNCOUNTED, AND SHOULD BE
SAFEGUARDED BY THE INSPECTOR OF
ELECTIONS UNTIL A QUORUM HAS
BEEN MET. THIS AVOIDS THE
POSSIBILITY OF A PARTIAL COUNT
AND LEAKED RESULTS AND SO FORTH,
WHICH WOULD, SUBJECT AN ELECTION
TO CHAOTIC SITUATION. AND
FINALLY, THE CURRENT LAW DOES
NOT INDICATE HOW MANY TIMES A
MEETING TO COUNT BALLOTS MAY BE
RECONVENED. SO THE NEW LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL THAT THE AUTHORS
PRESENTED DOESN'T CALL A SECOND
OR THIRD MEETING IT. IT
CONTINUES, IN THEORY, THE SAME
MEETING BY RECONVENING. BUT WHAT
THE BILL DOES NOT SAY IS HOW
MANY TIMES THIS RECONVENING CAN
OCCUR. WE RECOMMEND THAT IT BE
LIMITED AND WITH THOSE OFFERED
AMENDMENTS THAT WE STILL
CONTINUE TO HOPE WILL BE
ACCEPTED, WE DO ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE UNLESS THERE IS ACCEPTANCE
OF THE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU.
ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
TO AB 2460. SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE,
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NONE.
IS THERE A MOTION? SENATOR STERN
HAS MOVED THE BILL. ALL RIGHT,
SO, MEMBER TODD, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I REALLY WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
SECRETARY. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR STERN. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FOR ITEM NUMBER
11, AB 2460. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS, BURKE, I AM BURKE, I WILK
I WILK I ALLEN ASHBY. CABALLERO
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. I LAIRD LAIRD
I KNEEL I KNEEL I ROTH ROTH I
STERN, A STERN, I HOB 7 TO 0
SEVEN ZERO. WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT, NEXT PERSON PRESENT IN
ORDER IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACKSON. WE'RE GOING TO JUMP
WAY, WAY, WAY AHEAD TO FILE A
NUMBER 40. OKAY, I'M. IT WORKS.
SOMETIMES ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR, COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, AB 1818 WOULD ESTABLISH
A TWO YEAR PILOT PROGRAM,
DEVELOPED AND ADMINISTERED BY
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO ALLOW
OVERNIGHT PARKING ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES IN ORDER TO CREATE AND
DEVELOP BEST PRACTICES ON HOW TO
DO IT SAFELY AND REASONABLY. IF
THERE ARE STUDENTS WHO FIND
THEMSELVES TO BE HOMELESS AND
HAVE NOWHERE ELSE TO GO,
CONSISTENCY AND STABILITY IS THE
WAY TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO BE STABILIZED AND THEN
CONNECTED TO SERVICES, SO THEY
THEN CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE ALL
THEY HAVE TO DO IS CONCENTRATE
ON THEIR STUDIES, AND SO ONCE
AGAIN, WHAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT
THIS, ALSO IS THAT WE ARE WE ARE
CAREFUL TO PROVIDE LIABILITY
PROTECTIONS TO THE CSU AND, AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND DEFER TO
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICES OF EACH
INSTITUTION TO BE COLLABORATIVE
IN THEIR CREATION OF THE PILOT
PROGRAM. AGAIN, THIS IS THE LAST
RESORT. THIS IS NOT TO
SUPPLEMENT, ACTUALLY MORE, MORE
SUCCESSFUL STRATEGIES. BUT
AGAIN, WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE YOUNG THAT THESE STUDENTS
ARE SAFE AND THEY DO NOT HAVE TO
TAKE ADDITIONAL RISKS IN THEIR
HIGHER EDUCATION PURSUITS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JACKSON. LET ME
ASK, ARE YOU GOING TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED IN THE
ANALYSIS? I AM ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS. YES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB 1818, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. KIM LEWIS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. VOTE FOR STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION NOW. AB NUMBER 40,
FILE NUMBER 40 AB 1818. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED, PLEASE COME
FORWARD SEEING NO ONE COMING
FORWARD. LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. SENATOR LAIRD, I MOVE
THE BILL, AS AMENDED, HAS MOVED
THE BILL. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SEEING NONE. ALL
RIGHT, SUMMER JACKSON, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OH, I'M
SORRY WE WENT TOO FAST. ARE YOU
HERE TO TESTIFY ON ON AB 1818?
SO. OKAY, YOU GOT TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE AND TELL US THAT.
DAVID RAMIREZ WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. WIENER 18,
PRESIDENT OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENT STUDENT
ASSOCIATION, REPRESENTS 230,000
PLUS UNDERGRAD STUDENTS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CANTOR
MENDEZ, VICE CHAIR OF THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN RECENT
GRADUATE OF UC DAVIS. THANK YOU.
IN SUPPORT. YES, THANK YOU.
CAROLINE NGUYEN, POLICY DIRECTOR
OF THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. NOW LET ME TURN AGAIN
TO THE OPPOSITION. IF THE
OPPOSITION DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE
TO COME IN, GOING ONCE, GOING
TWICE. ALL RIGHT, SEEING NO
OPPOSITION, SENATOR STERN, I
BELIEVE, HAS MOVED THE BILL. OH,
I'M SORRY, SENATOR LAIRD. YOU
GUYS LOOK ALIKE. I'M VERY
DIFFICULT TO TELL YOU APART, SO.
ALL RIGHT. OH, OPPOSITION. OKAY.
ARE YOU OPPOSED? YES. ALL RIGHT,
COME ON UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
SORRY. THE FLOOR'S YOURS. OH.
THANK YOU, GOOD MORNING, DOCTOR.
JAMILA MOORE, VICE PRESIDENT OF
STUDENT AFFAIRS. EXCUSE ME. I
WAS RUNNING AND ENROLLMENT
MANAGEMENT AT SAN FRANCISCO
STATE UNIVERSITY. I'M HERE TO
SPEAK IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO AB 1818. I'M SURE EVERYONE'S
FAMILIAR WITH THE BILL. WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION AS THE STATE'S
EXTENSIVE INVESTMENTS IN
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS HAVE
SHOWN SUBSTANTIAL RESULTS. FOR
INSTANCE, THE CSU SUPPORTED
14,000 STUDENTS THROUGH VARIOUS
HOUSING ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS IN
2223, WITH AN ADDITIONAL 7600
STUDENTS RECEIVING EMERGENCY
FUNDING. WHEN WE ALLOCATE ANY
CAMPUS SPACE FOR PROGRAMS FOR
UNHOUSED INDIVIDUALS, WE MUST
CREATE AN ACTIVE SAFE ZONE
DURING ITS USE. THIS
NECESSITATES ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AND SECURITY. SUCH AN
APPROACH AN APPROACH IS AT ODDS
WITH OUR HOUSING PROGRAMS, WHICH
AIM TO PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH
STABLE AND SAFE ACCOMMODATIONS
BEHIND SECURE DOORS AND OUR
RESIDENTIAL COMMUNITIES, OR
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL HOTELS.
WE BELIEVE THAT OUR CURRENT
HOUSING PROGRAMS AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE A
GROWING IMPACT WITH LEGISLATIVE
SUPPORT PERMITTING STUDENTS TO
SLEEP IN THEIR CARS, AS PROPOSED
IN AB 18 1818 WOULD UNDERMINE
THESE PROGRAMS AND WOULD FURTHER
CONVEY A NEGATIVE MESSAGE ABOUT
THE DIGNITY AND WORTH OF OUR
STUDENTS. IF ENACTED, WE BELIEVE
THAT IT WILL FACE ADMINISTRATORS
AND CAMPUSES WILL FACE THE
CHALLENGING DECISION OF
DIVERTING FUNDS AND RESOURCES
FROM EFFECTIVE EXISTING PROGRAMS
THAT UPHOLD STUDENT DIGNITY TO
COSTLY PROGRAMS THAT POSE
SIGNIFICANT LIABILITY FOR THE
UNIVERSITY. FOR EXAMPLE, THIS
SUMMER WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF
REAPPLYING FOR RAPID REHOUSING
PROGRAM GRANT WITHIN THE CSU,
WHICH PROVIDES FUNDING THAT
DIRECTLY SUPPORTS HOUSING
STABILITY PROGRAMS AND SOURCES
WITHIN AB 18 SOURCES. IF AB 1818
PASSES ALONG WITH NAVIGATING A
DECREASE IN FUNDING FOR OUR
EXISTING PROGRAMS, WE WILL BE
REQUIRED TO REDIRECT FUNDS TO
IMPLEMENT THIS PROGRAM, DOING SO
WOULD COMPROMISE THE INTEGRITY
OF OUR EXISTING PROGRAMS AND OUR
ABILITY TO SUPPORT THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WITH HOUSING STABILITY.
VIÆT, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE OPPOSED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY OR
ON BEHALF OF WHOM? ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
OKAY WE ARE OPPOSED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT, LET ME GO
BACK TO OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 1818, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE SEEING
NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE. I'M SORRY. WOULD WE
BE ABLE TO ASK QUESTIONS? I
DON'T WANT THE WITNESS TO GO
AWAY. SURE. IF YOU'D REMAIN OKAY
. YES, HERE WOULD BE GOOD. BUT
RIGHT HERE, RIGHT IN THE ROOM.
RIGHT RIGHT HERE. SORRY WE DON'T
WANT YOU TO RUN AGAIN. ALL
RIGHT, ALL RIGHT, LET'S LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
OKAY. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. YES.
THANK YOU. SORRY FOR THAT
COMMITTEE. SO CITRUS COLLEGE,
I'M KEISHA HUNT WITH NOSSAMAN
FOR CITRUS COLLEGE AS WELL AS
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE, AS WELL AS MOUNT SAC OR
AN OPPOSITION PARTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY BACK TO
COMMITTEE, SENATOR ROTH, DID YOU
HAVE A QUESTION? I HAVE A
COUPLE, FIRST, TO THE AUTHOR,
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT A PILOT
PROGRAM AND THE NUMBER IS 5 OR
20, IS THAT MANDATORY THAT 20 BE
SELECTED OR MUST THE
INSTITUTIONS APPLY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PILOT PROGRAM
? YES. IT IS MANDATORY THAT 20
BE SELECTED, BUT IT IS UP TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO DETERMINE
WHICH OF THOSE 20 THERE WILL BE.
WHAT IF THE CHANCELLOR
DETERMINES THAT THEY'RE NOT 20
INSTITUTIONS IN THE SYSTEM? FOR
EXAMPLE, IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM THAT HAVE
APPROPRIATE FACILITIES TO ALLOW
THIS SORT OF PROGRAM TO SUCCEED?
WELL, THAT'S WHY IT'S A PILOT
PROGRAM, BECAUSE THE REASON WHY
WE CHOSE SO MANY, BECAUSE WE
KNOW DIFFERENT CAMPUSES HAVE
DIFFERENT CONFIGURATIONS. SO
WHAT BEST PRACTICES CAN BE
ESTABLISHED NO MATTER WHAT
CONFIGURATION IT IS? RIGHT. SO
FOR INSTANCE, WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
A THE MOST SAFE, PARKING LOT, IS
IN ONE PLACE, BUT THE NEAREST
RESTROOM IS ACROSS CAMPUS. WHAT
PRACTICES AND PROTOCOLS NEED TO
BE PUT IN PLACE TO DO THAT?
RIGHT. AND SO THAT'S WHY THIS IS
A STUDY TO DETERMINE THAT,
DIFFERENT DEPENDING ON THE
DIFFERENT VARIATIONS OF THE
CAMPUS THAT BEST PRACTICES CAN
BE ESTABLISHED AND ACTUALLY
CREATE. DOING THIS IS ACTUALLY
IS AN ESTABLISHED BEST PRACTICE
FOR HOMELESS, WE'RE JUST WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO DO IT NOW ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES. WELL, YOU
KNOW, I'M SUPPORTIVE, BUT I
THINK MOVING FORWARD YOU MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER MODIFYING THE
LANGUAGE SLIGHTLY TO DIRECT THE
STATE CHANCELLOR, IN THE CASE OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM FOR
EXAMPLE, TO SELECT UP TO 20,
WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE CHANCELLOR
THE FLEXIBILITY TO DETERMINE
THAT THERE MAY ONLY BE 17 OR 16
CAMPUSES THAT ARE PROPERLY
EQUIPPED TO SAFELY AND
EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM. JUST A SUGGESTION.
OKAY, NOW TO THE OPPOSITION. SO
GIVEN ALL THE EFFORTS THAT
YOU'VE MADE AND MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE CHAIRED BUDGET SUB ONE HAVE
MADE AND OVER THE PAST YEARS TO
TRY TO BED DOWN, SO TO SPEAK,
STUDENT HOUSING ON CAMPUSES AND
PROVIDE ALTERNATIVES. IF BRICK
AND MORTAR DOESN'T EXIST. CAN
YOU GIVE ME AN IDEA OF HOW MANY
UNHOUSED STUDENTS EXIST? FOR
EXAMPLE, IN THE CSU SYSTEM OR IN
YOUR CAMPUS OR BOTH? WELL, IT
IT, IT VARIES. IT VARIES FROM
SEMESTER TO SEMESTER BECAUSE IT
IS A ON WE HAVE BASIC NEEDS
OFFICES. AND SO WE CAN HAVE 100
STUDENTS ONE SEMESTER. WE CAN
HAVE 125. THE NEXT SEMESTER. WE
CAN HAVE 230 IN 1 YEAR. THESE
ARE UNHOUSED STUDENTS DESPITE
OUR BEST EFFORTS, DESPITE OUR
BEST EFFORTS. THESE ARE STUDENTS
WHO HAVE COME IN ASKING FOR
ASSISTANCE WITH HOUSING THROUGH
OUR BASIC NEEDS OFFICE, BECAUSE
WE ALSO HAVE HOUSING
COORDINATORS, WE HAVE EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE WORKING WITH
THESE STUDENTS WHO HAVE
IDENTIFIED THEMSELVES IN NEED OF
HOUSING. AND SO IT DOES VARY. SO
FOR EXAMPLE, WE SUPPORTED AS A
SYSTEM IN THE CSU 14,000
STUDENTS THROUGH VARIOUS HOUSING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS IN 22, 23,
WITH ABOUT AN ADDITIONAL 7600
STUDENTS RECEIVING EMERGENCY
HOUSING, BUT MY QUESTION GOES TO
THIS DESPITE OUR BEST EFFORTS,
HOW MANY STUDENTS REMAIN
UNHOUSED DUE TO THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE BRICK AND MORTAR
HOUSING AND WE DON'T HAVE HOTEL
VOUCHERS ON YOUR CAMPUS FOR
EXAMPLE, ARE THERE ANY? WELL, AT
SAN FRANCISCO STATE, THOSE
STUDENTS WHO HAVE COME FORWARD,
WE HELPED 5800 STUDENTS IN 22,
23 AND IN 23, 24 WE HELPED, 173
STUDENTS WHO IDENTIFIED AS IN
NEED OF EMERGENCY HOUSING. DO WE
KNOW WHETHER THERE ARE STUDENTS
WHO REMAIN UNHOUSED AT YOUR
PARTICULAR CSU, YOUR CSU RIGHT
THERE COULD BE. BUT UNLESS THE
STUDENT SELF-IDENTIFIES I WE
DON'T KNOW. THE STUDENT HAS TO
COME FORWARD. OUR PROCESS
CURRENTLY, SENATOR, IS THAT
STUDENTS WILL IDENTIFY THAT THEY
NEED HOUSING. WE WILL EITHER
WORK THROUGH OUR RAPID REHOUSING
PROGRAM AND OUR BASIC NEEDS.
OFFICE TO ASSIST THEM EITHER
WITH ON CAMPUS HOUSING OR OR
FINDING A HOTEL VOUCHER TO
ASSIST THEM IF THERE'S NOT SPACE
ON CAMPUS. WE CURRENTLY AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE HAVE SPACE ON
CAMPUS, SO WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
HOUSE STUDENTS WHO ARE IN
BETWEEN OR IN AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION THROUGH OUR
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING PROGRAM. DO
YOU KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THERE
ARE SEVERAL CAMPUSES IN THE CSU
SYSTEM? DO YOU KNOW WHETHER THE
SYSTEM AS A WHOLE HAS HAS AN
UNMET NEED FOR HOUSING? IN OTHER
WORDS, ARE THERE UNHOUSED
STUDENTS SEMESTER TO SEMESTER TO
SEMESTER BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
ENOUGH ROOMS AND NOT ENOUGH
HOTEL VOUCHERS? WELL, WORKING
THROUGH OUR RAPID REHOUSING
PROGRAM, I'M SURE THERE COULD BE
AT EVERY CAMPUS SOME. BUT ONCE
AGAIN, THE STUDENT HAS TO
IDENTIFY SELF-IDENTIFY. IF THEY
DON'T SELF-IDENTIFY, WE'RE NOT
CERTAIN, BUT THESE STUDENTS THAT
HAVE COME FORWARD, TO MY
KNOWLEDGE, WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ASSIST STUDENTS THAT HAVE COME
FORWARD AND IDENTIFIED THEY NEED
SOME ASSISTANCE WITH HOUSING.
ALL RIGHT. ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS? SENATOR ROTH? NO.
ALL RIGHT. SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. I'M STRUGGLING.
MAYBE NOT SO MUCH WITH THE HEART
OF THE BILL, BUT AROUND IT, THE
CONTEXT OF THE BILL I'M TRYING
TO LOOK PAST, ONE OF YOUR LEAD
WITNESSES, THE VICE CHAIR AT
UTSA, WHO JUST WALKED UP HERE
WITH A RIVER TO THE SEA SHIRT,
TELLING ME THAT MY FOLKS SHOULD
BE ERASED FROM THE ENTIRE MAP.
SO I'M WONDERING WHAT THE AGENDA
IS FOR UTSA AND WHAT A PRIORITY
IS. THAT'S A VERY HARD THING TO
GET PAST. LET ME PUT THAT ONE
ASIDE AS I'M FORCED TO DO ALL
THE TIME. I'M ALSO STRUGGLING
WITH THE FACT THAT THE ASSEMBLY
DECIDED NOT TO INCLUDE HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THE EDUCATION BOND
TO ACTUALLY GET DOLLARS FOR
HOUSING. STUDENTS REFUSED TO
EVEN ADD STUDENT HOUSING TO THE
EDUCATION BOND. SO IT SEEMS LIKE
WE'RE PUTTING A LOT OF DEMANDS
ON OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
WITHOUT ACTUALLY PUTTING THE
DOLLARS THERE, TO BACK UP WHAT
WE ENDEAVOR FOR, I DO NOT WANT
TO SEE STUDENTS ON THE STREET.
WE HAVE STUDENTS STARVING. I
IT'S A SERIOUS ISSUE. BUT I WANT
A SERIOUS SOLUTION. SO I KNOW
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. ASSERT
THAT THE PILOT PROGRAM WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION, I
GUESS I WOULD. I WOULD CONCUR
WITH, MY COLLEAGUES
RECOMMENDATION. THERE BE SOME
FLEXIBILITY HERE, BUT I ALSO.
YEAH, I'M STRUGGLING WITH HOW TO
HOW TO VOTE, GIVEN ALL THAT
EXTRA CONTEXT HERE. SO HOPE YOU
CAN APPRECIATE MY COMMENTS.
YEAH, I APPRECIATE THAT. THANK
YOU. SENATOR, SENATOR ROTH, JUST
A QUICK JUST A QUICK FOLLOW UP,
WHICH WAS MY POINT TO THE
AUTHOR. I THINK AS YOU MOVE, IF
THIS BILL MOVES OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE AS YOU MOVE FORWARD TO
APPROPRIATIONS, I THINK YOU
SHOULD TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT THE
ARCHITECTURE OF THE BILL AND
GIVE THE STATE CHANCELLOR THE
ABILITY TO ASSESS. AND, OF
COURSE, THE CHANCELLOR AT THE
CSU AS WELL. THE SYSTEM, THE
ABILITY TO ASSESS WHAT THE NEED
IS AT VARIOUS CAMPUSES AND IF
THERE IS A NEED, IF THERE IS AN
UNMET NEED FOR HOUSING AND WE
HAVE UNHOUSED STUDENTS, DESPITE
OUR BEST EFFORTS TO DECIDE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PILOT
PROGRAM AND SELECT CAMPUSES TO
DO THIS, AS OPPOSED TO A
BLANKET, 20 OR A BLANKET FIVE,
WHICH PUTS A BURDEN ON SCHOOLS
THAT MAY ALREADY HAVE SOLVED THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A
WE DON'T HAVE A STUDY TO LOOK AT
THAT SAYS CAMPUS. JUST A
SUGGESTION. THANK YOU FOR
TOLERATING, TWO BITES AT THE
APPLE, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ROTH. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? IS THERE A MOTION? DO
YOU HAVE ONE? OH, I'M SORRY,
SENATOR LAIRD HAS MOVED THE
BILL, ALL RIGHT, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACKSON? RIGHT I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS OF, OF
MY COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE ON THE
COMMITTEE. I WOULD JUST SAY A
FEW THINGS. NUMBER ONE, THIS IS
ANOTHER WAY TO IDENTIFY, THOSE
STUDENTS, BECAUSE THEY WILL BE
THEY WILL HAVE TO ACTUALLY APPLY
FOR A SPECIAL PERMIT TO DO IT.
AND THAT'S THE PERFECT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE INSTITUTION
TO THEN SAY, WELL, WE ACTUALLY
HAVE THESE ADDITIONAL SERVICES
FOR YOU. AND SO THEREFORE, THE
PARKING LOT IS NO LONGER
SOMETHING YOU NEED TO DO. RIGHT,
AGAIN, THIS IS MEANT TO BE A
LAST RESORT. AND THE REASON WHY
WE PUT UPON APPROPRIATION IS TO
ENSURE THAT THE MONEY IS NOT
BEING DIVERTED FOR MORE
EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS. RIGHT BUT
THIS IS, AGAIN, AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S A
BACKSTOP. AND SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. WE'RE
TRYING TO BE AS THOUGHTFUL AS
POSSIBLE, BUT AGAIN, THIS IS
ACTUALLY A BEST PRACTICE, IT'S
JUST A BEST PRACTICE THAT NOBODY
WANTS TO SEE AT SOME POINT. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, SOMETIMES IT
MIGHT BE NECESSARY. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT,
MADAM SECRETARY, THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION BY SENATOR LAIRD. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 40, AB 1818. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS IS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG
UMBERG I WILK ALLEN. ASHBY.
CABALLERO. DURAZO CARUSO I.
LAIRD. LAIRD I NILO. NILO NØ.
ROTH. ROTH I. STERN WAHAB. 4 TO
1. 4 TO 1. WE'LL PUT THAT ON.
CALL. ALL RIGHT. NEXT I SEE,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA.
THAT WOULD BE FILE NUMBER 15. IF
YOU'RE IN THE HALLWAY ON FILE AN
ITEM NUMBER 15, AB 2023, PLEASE
COME INTO THE COMMITTEE HEARING
ROOM. ALL RIGHT, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS TODAY PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL 2023, WHICH CREATES PARITY
IN THE HOUSING ELEMENT REVIEW
PROCESS. THE HOUSING ELEMENT
MUST BE TIMELY AND REFLECT THE
COMMUNITY'S PLAN TO ADDRESS
THEIR SHARE OF THE REGION'S
HOUSING NEEDS. ONCE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AGREES, A
LOCAL HOUSING ELEMENT COMPLIES
WITH THE LAW. THE HOUSING
ELEMENT HAS A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION OF VALIDITY THAT
THIS MEANS THAT HCD'S FINDINGS
OF COMPLIANCE RECEIVES DEFERENCE
IN COURT, AND ANY PARTY
CHALLENGING THE ELEMENT HAS A
HIGHER BAR TO MEET. TO PROVE
THAT HCD WAS INCORRECT. HOWEVER,
THERE IS NO EQUIVALENT PROVISION
IF A CITY OR COUNTY DOES NOT
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS SET BY HCD
OR DOES NOT TAKE ANY ACTION
REGARDING ITS ADOPTED HOUSING
ELEMENT. THIS LOOPHOLE ALLOWS
CERTAIN CITIES TO DISREGARD
HCD'S EXPERT FINDINGS AND BYPASS
RECOMMENDATIONS AIMED AT
STRENGTHENING THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENTS TO ACHIEVE COMPLIANCE.
THIS OVERSIGHT UNDERMINES THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL JURISDICTIONS ADOPT AND
ENFORCE ROBUST, LEGALLY
COMPLIANT HOUSING ELEMENTS.
WHILE THE MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA
JURISDICTIONS DO ADOPT HOUSING
ELEMENTS THAT HCD DEEMS
COMPLIANT, THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS.
THIS OVERSIGHT UNDERMINES THE
STATE'S EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT
ALL JURISDICTIONS ADOPT AND
ENFORCE ROBUST, LEGALLY
COMPLIANT HOUSING ELEMENTS. I
BELIEVE WE ALL HAVE A PART IN
ADDRESSING THE STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS AND WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT
AND TO ANSWER ANY QUESTION IS
ANJA LAWLER, THE LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH THE PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW PROJECT AND RAFA
SONNENFELD, A POLICY DIRECTOR
WITH YIMBY ACTION. GREAT. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. I WILL NOT
TAKE TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING,
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ANDY LAWLER
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW PROJECT. PLP IS A
NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATION THAT DOES HOUSING
ELEMENT ADVOCACY STATEWIDE, WE
DON'T THINK IT MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE THAT HCD'S FINDINGS
RECEIVE MORE DEFERENCE IN COURT
IF THEY FIND THE HOUSING ELEMENT
TO BE IN COMPLIANCE THAN OUT OF
COMPLIANCE. WE THINK THIS BILL
IS JUST COMMON SENSE AND CREATES
PARITY SO THAT THE EXPERT
AGENCY'S FINDINGS GET DEFERENCE
IN COURT, REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THEY FIND A JURISDICTION IN OR
OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW.
WE THINK THIS WILL REDUCE
LITIGATION, ENCOURAGE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO SIMPLY GET THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENTS DONE. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SIR, WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. GOOD MORNING, RAFA
SONNENFELD, REPRESENTING
CO-SPONSORS YIMBY LAW, THE LEGAL
ARM OF THE NATIONWIDE PRO
HOUSING MOVEMENT AND AN
AFFILIATE OF YIMBY ACTION, THIS
IS A GOOD GOVERNANCE BILL THAT
HELPS TO ENSURE EACH CITY'S
FINDINGS OF HOUSING ELEMENT
COMPLIANCE ARE GIVEN DEFERENCE
IN COURT REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THOSE FINDINGS ARE, I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SIR. ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT? THIS IS NOW APPROPRIATE
FOR ME TO TESTIMONY NAME
ORGANIZATION IF YOU HAVE ONE,
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING. CATHERINE CHARLES,
ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSE IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NO ONE ELSE. OKAY. NOW WE
WILL MOVE TO OPPONENTS. DO WE
HAVE ANY PRIMARY OPPOSITION
ADVOCATES? WE DO HAVE A SEAT AT
THE TABLE. AND YOU'VE GOT TWO
MINUTES. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
PERFECT. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BRADY GORTON ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND A RESPECTFUL OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. OUR
CONCERNS ARE TWOFOLD, THE MAIN
ONE BEING GIVING HCD MORE POWER
FOR HOUSING ELEMENTS,
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE'S
DIFFERENT, CERTIFICATIONS AND
STANDARDS THAT WE NEED TO REACH.
BUT OUR CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND
THE LANGUAGE IS GOING TO BE VERY
CONFUSING FOR LOCAL CITIES ON
THE GROUND. BUT I THINK MORE
IMPORTANTLY, OUR CONCERN IS WITH
THE SECTION ON THE BILL THAT
WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WHEN THEY'RE DOING THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT AMENDMENTS, TO DO A FULL
120 DAYS TO LOOK BACK AT THOSE
AMENDMENTS. DESPITE ALL THE
PUBLIC COMMENT EARLY IN THE
PROCESS, WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
THAT THIS IS GOING TO PUT CITIES
ON THE DEFENSE, AND WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH
GETTING OUR HOUSING ELEMENTS IN
COMPLIANCE WITHOUT SPECIFIC
FINDINGS, AS WELL AS GOING
THROUGH THE PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY
PROCESS AGAIN AND AGAIN. WE'RE
ALL FOR PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY, BUT
BELIEVE THAT WE DO OUR DUE
DILIGENCE EARLY IN OUR CONCERN
THAT THIS WILL FURTHER DELAY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM BEING
ABLE TO GET A CERTIFIED HOUSING
ELEMENT AND ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL.
SO WE'VE OFFERED OUR THOSE
AMENDMENTS TO THE AUTHORS OFFICE
AND STAFF AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THOSE CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS,
BUT IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION, COME UP HERE AND
PROVIDE ME TWO TESTIMONY. ETHAN
NAGLER, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
EASTVALE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION, AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF RANCHO LUNGO,
RESPECTFULLY. THE AMENDED. THANK
YOU. SERIOUSLY. THAT'S IT. OKAY.
VERY GOOD. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. WE HAVE FOUR.
DO WE HAVE MORE? WAIT, THERE'S
MORE. SORRY, I WAS RUNNING HERE.
THIS IS ANDREW DOSS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
AND ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT. WE JUST
MISSED IT. OKAY THANKS FOR
COMING AND SHARING. ALL RIGHT.
PULL IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS, CONCERNS.
SENATOR STERN. YEAH. THANK YOU,
THOUGHTS ON JUST WANT TO GET
YOUR RESPONSE OPPOSITION
WILLINGNESS, OPENNESS ON THE
AMENDMENTS FROM LEAGUE OF
CITIES. WE HAVE LISTENED TO THE
OPPOSITION AS WE'VE MADE OUR
WAY. WE'RE ALWAYS WILLING TO
LISTEN MORE. BUT THIS IS REALLY
FOR THE NARROW GROUP OF CITIES
THAT ARE USING STOLEN DELAY
TACTICS. AND WE HAVE SEEN THIS.
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT THE
MAJORITY OF CITIES. WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE VERY GOOD ACTORS IN
HOUSING THAT WANT TO DO ALL THEY
CAN TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS, BUT WE DO HAVE SOME
CITIES THAT HAVE USED EVERY,
TACTIC TO NOT HAVING A COMPLIANT
HOUSING ELEMENT. IF YOU WANT TO
ADD ANY. SURE. I UNFORTUNATELY,
THE AMENDMENTS THAT THE LEAGUE
HAS OFFERED, WE THINK TAKE THE
BILL IN THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION.
BUT IF WE CAN COME TO SOME
AGREEMENT ON ALTERNATE LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS, THAT IS DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT THEY'VE OFFERED, WE'RE
OBVIOUSLY WILLING TO HAVE THAT
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. BUT WE
REALLY THINK THAT, THE BILL IS
FAIRLY COMMON SENSE AND THAT SO
KIND OF NO IS THE ANSWER, AND
FROM THE LEAGUE JUST ARE THERE
ARE THERE AMENDED AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU ALL HAVE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT? BECAUSE MY CONCERN IS
JUST GIVING SUCH WEIGHT WITHOUT,
YOU KNOW, THIS REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION PIECE, THAT SORT OF
HCD'S WORD IS, IS, IS,
INFALLIBLE AND WILL NEVER BE
CHALLENGED, EVEN WHEN
COMPLICATED ISSUES AROUND
SURVEYING LAND, NEW
DEVELOPMENTS, SPECIFICALLY IN
FIRE ZONES WHERE, YOU KNOW, I,
YOU KNOW, I HAVE EXTRA
SENSITIVITY, AND, YOU KNOW,
GRADING AND VARIOUS SORT OF
ACCESS ISSUES AND THINGS LIKE
THAT ARE TOUGH TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT UP HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
BUT HAVE YOU GUYS GIVEN ANY
THOUGHT AS A REASONABLE COUNTY
HERE JUST TO SO I KNOW WHAT'S
COMING ON THE FLOOR. YEAH. SO
THE ONES THAT WE LOOKED AT
LOOKING AT THE WE'RE STILL GOING
TO GIVE THE REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION. WE ARE JUST GOING
TO SAY THAT THEIR FINDINGS ARE
VALID, MEANING THAT WHAT THEY
SAY EITHER WAY GOES. THAT WAS
THE LANGUAGE THAT WE HAD OFFERED
THAT WAS FROM OUR LEGAL COUNSEL.
THE BACK HALF, WHICH I THINK IS
THE BIG, BIGGER CONCERN IS THE
TIMELINES FOR THE AMENDMENTS
PROCESS FOR THE HOUSING
ELEMENTS. THAT'S GOING TO BE
CONCERNING FOR OUR CITIES TO,
YOU KNOW, LISTEN TO HCD GET THAT
FEEDBACK AND DO WHAT'S NEEDED TO
MEET AND GET A CERTIFIED HOUSING
ELEMENT. THAT'S WHERE OUR
CONCERN IS, AND WE DON'T FEEL
LIKE THAT. IF THE GOAL IS FOR
HCD TO HAVE A STRONGER CHALLENGE
IN COURT, WE'RE WILLING TO GIVE
ON THAT. BUT TO MAKE IT MORE
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE, BUT MORE SO LOOK AT THE
TIMELINES ASPECT AND SEE IF WE
CAN STRIKE THAT LANGUAGE. I
BELIEVE IT'S IN SECTION FOUR,
BUT I CAN'T REMEMBER THE EXACT.
I GUESS WHERE THIS GOES IS WE'RE
PROBABLY GOING TO END UP IN
BUILDER'S REMEDY LAND IN A LOT
OF THESE CASES, AND I STILL KNOW
THAT THAT'S AN UNRESOLVED ISSUE.
SO THAT'S THAT'S MY THAT'S MY
CHALLENGE ON THE BILL IS HOW TO
LAND, NOT KNOWING WHERE THAT'S
GOING TO LAND. SO ANYHOW, THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME WEIGH IN
HERE. THAT WAS IT. OKAY. ANY
NOTHING ELSE. SOMEBODY LIKE TO
MAKE A MOTION. OKAY. MOVED BY
SENATOR DURAZO, SECRETARY. I
GUESS I SHOULD LET YOU CLOSE? WE
HAVE 70 BILLS TODAY, SO, YOU
KNOW, WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER 15, AB 2023.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG WILK NÓ
WILK NÓ ALLEN. ASHBY. CABALLERO
DURAZO DURAZO I LAIRD. LAIRD I
NILO. NILO. NØ ROTH I OKAY. ROTH
I STERN. WAHAB 3 TO 2. ALL
RIGHT. 3 TO 2, WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
THANK YOU. NOW, I WOULD LIKE TO
BRING UP ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHECO
, BUT I'VE BEEN TOLD I HAVE TO
GO AND FILE ORDERS, SO I GUESS
IT'S, MR. TING WHO'S NOT GOING
TO BE A GENTLEMAN AND GO AHEAD
AND TAKE IT. OKAY. LET'S GO. SO
WE HAVE JUST ONE BILL. IT'S. I
DO HAVE ONE BILL, BUT I HAVE TWO
BILLS I'M PREVENTING FOR SPEAKER
EMERITUS. RENDON OKAY, WELL,
WE'LL DO YOUR BILL FOR YOU
PREFER TO DO YOUR BILL FIRST?
YES, PLEASE. OKAY. SO THIS FINAL
ITEM, TEN AB 1814. YES. AND WITH
THAT, PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. SO AB 1814 PROVIDES A
FIRST STEP IN PROTECTING
PEOPLE'S PRIVACY FROM FACIAL
RECOGNITION. IT PREVENTS LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM BEING ABLE TO
ARREST, SEARCH, OR GET A WARRANT
APPROVED BY A JUDGE. WITH THE
SOLE BASIS FOR THAT ACTION IS
FACIAL RECOGNITION MATCH WITH A
CIVIL PENALTY OF UP TO $25,000.
FOR THAT VIOLATION, THIS WOULD
MEAN THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT WOULD
HAVE TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
EVIDENCE IN ORDER TO DO ANY OF
THOSE ACTIONS OUTSIDE OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION MATCH. AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW, I DID A BILL IN 2019
HAVING A THREE YEAR MORATORIUM
ON FACIAL RECOGNITION IN THE USE
OF BODY CAMERAS THAT MORATORIUM
EXPIRED AS OF JANUARY 1ST, 2023.
SINCE THEN, I'VE BEEN WORKING TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WAYS TO
REGULATE FACIAL RECOGNITION, TO
PROVIDE GUIDELINES IN ITS USE,
CURRENTLY, THERE ARE NO STATES
THAT HAVE BANNED FACIAL
RECOGNITION, ONLY REGULATED IT.
THIS BILL, AGAIN, IS NOT
PREEMPTIVE. SO MY CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO, WHICH HAS BANNED THE
TECHNOLOGY, WOULD NOT PREEMPTED
BY THIS BILL. SHOULD CITIES
OTHER CITIES WANT TO TAKE
GREATER ACTION ON FACIAL
RECOGNITION, THEY WOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO SO. THIS DOES NOT
PREEMPT THEM IN THE FUTURE, AS
WELL, WITH THAT, I HAVE, MR.
FELDMAN AS MY WITNESS CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. JONATHAN FELDMAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR ALL THE YEARS THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS, WHICH
STARTED WITH US IN OPPOSITION OF
EACH OTHER ON THE MORATORIUM.
BUT, HAVE SINCE WORKED TOGETHER,
RUNNING A BILL LAST YEAR TO TRY
AND SET COMPREHENSIVE STANDARDS.
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT BILL DIDN'T
MAKE IT THROUGH. AND SO THIS
YEAR, TAKING, AS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED, A MEANINGFUL FIRST
STEP TO SET, WHAT I THINK IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT RESTRICTION ON
THE SOLE USE OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION FOR ARREST,
APPREHENSION OR WARRANT FOR
AFFIDAVIT. THE TECHNOLOGY ITSELF
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND AN
EFFECTIVE TOOL FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IT'S BEEN PROVEN
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO HELP AND
ASSIST IN LOCATING, VIOLENT
CRIMINALS. THOSE WHO HAVE
COMMITTED SEXUAL ASSAULT CRIMES,
IT WAS USED IN BOSTON DURING THE
MARATHON BOMBING TO LOCATE THOSE
SUSPECTS. IT IS AN IMPORTANT
TOOL, BUT AT THE SAME TIME, LAW
ENFORCEMENT UNDERSTANDS THAT WE
DO HAVE TO REGULATE IT AND
PROTECT FROM ABUSES. THIS BILL
TAKES THAT FIRST IMPORTANT STEP,
AS WE HAD MENTIONED, AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO, YOU KNOW,
ENSURING THAT THE COMMUNITY
UNDERSTANDS THAT THERE ARE
SAFEGUARDS, THERE ARE
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE, BUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN USE, THE TOOL IN
A MEANINGFUL WAY TO PROTECT
THEIR COMMUNITIES. SO WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE, VOTE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. DO WE HAVE ANY MONEY TO
TEST? TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MIC NAME
ORGANIZATION IF YOU HAVE ONE
POSITION ON THE, POSITION ON THE
BILL. GOOD MORNING AGAIN. CHAIR
MEMBERS. BRADY GARDNER, ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
RUBALCAVA WITH NIELSEN MERKSAMER
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF VISALIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THAT'S
IT. OKAY. DO WE HAVE DO WE HAVE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN UP? OH, NO.
SORRY MARGARET GLADSTEIN
SECURITY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
PRIMARY WITNESSES. COME ON UP.
YOU EACH GET TWO MINUTES AND
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY, GO AHEAD
AND PROCEED. IF YOU LISTEN, I
KEEP SPEAKING TO THE MIC. IF YOU
DON'T MIND. MEADOW VILLAS, ON
BEHALF OF THE TRANS LATINA
COALITION AND OPPOSITION TODAY,
I WANT TO ADDRESS AN URGENT
ISSUE THAT TOUCHES UPON PRIVACY,
CIVIL RIGHTS AND THE EQUITABLE
TREATMENT OF ALL INDIVIDUALS.
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY,
ITS DEPLOYMENT BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT CARRIES SIGNIFICANT
AND OFTEN HARMFUL CONSEQUENCES,
PARTICULARLY FOR THE TRANSGENDER
COMMUNITY AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. AB 1814 WILL DO NOTHING
TO PROTECT AGAINST THESE HARMS.
THE TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY FACES
FACES UNIQUE CHALLENGES WITH
FACIAL RECOGNITION. MANY
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCE FREQUENT
MISIDENTIFICATION DUE TO CHANGES
IN THEIR APPEARANCE OVER TIME.
THIS MISIDENTIFICATION CAN LEAD
TO DISTRESSING ENCOUNTERS AND
DISCRIMINATION. IMAGINE GOING
THROUGH ALREADY CHALLENGING
PROCESS OF TRANSITIONING AND
THEN BEING CONSISTENTLY
MISRECOGNIZED BY A SYSTEM THAT
FAILS TO UNDERSTAND YOUR
IDENTITY. THIS NOT ONLY INVADES
PRIVATE PERSONAL PRIVACY, BUT
ALSO INVALIDATES THEIR IDENTITY,
CAUSING EMOTIONAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL HARM, AND CAN
RESULT IN OUTING A TRANSGENDER
PERSON. YET, AB 1814 IS SILENT
ON THESE ISSUES, COMMUNICATING
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT THE
RECOGNITION IS USED AS A SOLE
BASIS FOR PROBABLE CAUSE, EVEN
THOUGH THAT IS A CONTINUAL
FACIAL RECOGNITION LINEUP,
SOMETHING THAT IS NOT ALLOWED.
CURRENTLY, AB 1814 WILL FURTHER
PUT A VULNERABLE COMMUNITY OF
RISK, VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
THAT MORE LIKELY TO BE IN STATE
DATABASES, WE MUST ASK OURSELVES
, DO WE WANT TO LIVE IN A
SOCIETY WHERE OUR FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS ARE COMPROMISED BY FLAWED
TECHNOLOGY, AND WHERE PEOPLE ARE
PUT IN PERPETUAL VIRTUAL LINEUPS
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY HAVE USED
GOVERNMENT SERVICES? THE ANSWER
IS CLEAR LAW ENFORCEMENT DOES
NOT NEED TO USE FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY. THERE
ARE MORE EFFECTIVE, LESS
INTRUSIVE METHODS TO ENSURE
PUBLIC SAFETY WITHOUT
SACRIFICING OUR CIVIL LIBERTIES.
AB 1814 TAKES US TO THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION. INSTEAD, LET US WORK
TOGETHER TO CREATE A SOCIETY
THAT VALUES PRIVACY, EQUALITY
AND JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. TWO MINUTES AND THREE
SECONDS. THAT'S PRETTY GOOD. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS KELLY
WALTERS. I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND A FORMER
CRIMINAL DEFENSE ATTORNEY IN
CHICAGO. I'M HERE TODAY
COMPELLED TO SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT
THE HARMFUL IMPACTS ON OUR
COMMUNITIES AND FAMILIES THAT
THEY WILL FACE IF THIS BILL WERE
TO BE PASSED FIRST, AB 1814 DOES
NOT ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT ARISE FROM
TECHNOLOGICAL INFANCY WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES OF USING NON-ROBUST
TECHNOLOGIES FOR POLICING AND
CONVICTIONS. IT IS NECESSARY TO
OUTLINE CLEAR AND RESEARCHED
LIMITATIONS REGARDING FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY. AB 1814
FAILS TO PROVIDE THESE REFORMS.
AB 1814 STATES THAT IF PASSED,
IT WOULD, QUOTE, PROHIBIT A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY OR PEACE
OFFICER FROM USING A FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY GENERATED
MATCH AS THE SOLE BASIS FOR
PROBABLE CAUSE IN AN ARREST OR
SEARCH, UNQUOTE. END QUOTE. IT
ALSO SAYS IT WOULD PROHIBIT A
JUDGE FROM GRANTING AN
APPLICATION FOR A WARRANT BASED
SOLELY ON A FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY MATCH BY SUGGESTING
THAT FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY IS NOT ROBUST, ROBUST
ENOUGH TO ACT AS PROBABLE CAUSE.
THIS BILL FAILS IN ITS PURSUIT
OF REFORM BY LACKING EFFECTIVE
REGULATIONS REGARDING FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY. AB 18,
WHILE AB 1814 CLAIMS TO MINIMIZE
THE POSSIBLE HARMFUL
CONSEQUENCES OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY USED IN
POLICING, IT UNFORTUNATELY DOES
NOT PREVENT FALSE MATCHES AND
ONLY INCENTIVIZES LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO CONFIRM THESE
WRONGFUL BELIEFS AND OTHER PARTS
OF AN INVESTIGATION. FURTHER,
DELEGITIMIZING AND CONTAMINATING
THE ENTIRE INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS
. IN THE CASES OF WRONGFUL
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
MATCHES THAT WE KNOW OF. POLICE
FELL INTO THE EXCUSE ME MATCHES
THAT WE KNOW OF. POLICE FELL
INTO THE TRAP OF AUTOMATION
BIAS, A PROCESS WHEREIN POLICE
ARE SUBCONSCIOUSLY ENCOURAGED TO
SEARCH FOR EVIDENCE THAT
SUPPLEMENTS A FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY MATCH, AND TO IGNORE
EXONERATING EVIDENCE, ESPECIALLY
WHEN GIVEN THE TYPE OF WARNING
THAT 1814 WOULD REQUIRE FOR
EXAMPLE, WHEN GIVEN A PHOTO
LINEUP OF A SUPPOSED FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY, MATCH
POLICE AND EYEWITNESSES WILL
OFTEN ASSUME THAT THE SUSPECT
MUST BE PRESENT, EVEN THOUGH THE
OVERTLY FLAWED TECHNOLOGY
FREQUENTLY DOES NOT PROVIDE A
CORRECT MESSAGE. OUR CHAIR, IF
YOU COULD DRAW TO A CONCLUSION,
I ABSOLUTELY CAN. THE REALITY OF
1814 DOES NOT INTRODUCE ANY
SUBSTANTIAL REFORM. INSTEAD OF A
SINGLE VAGUE PROHIBITION, ONE
WHICH DOES LITTLE TO REGULATE
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
USAGE, THE BILL SHOULD OUTLINE
STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCIES REGARDING THE USE OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY. THIS INCLUDES
MANDATES ON HOW THIS DATA IS
UTILIZED. YOU ARE AGAINST THE
BILL. OKAY. THANK YOU. THAT WAS
A GOOD TRY. THANK YOU CAN TELL.
OKAY. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD. NAME
ORGANIZATION. IF YOU HAVE ONE
POSITION ON THE BILL BECCA
KRAMER MATTER HERE. AS A
TECHNICAL WITNESS FOR THE
OPPOSITION AND ALSO HERE
REPRESENTING ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION NATIONAL CENTER FOR
LESBIAN RIGHTS, CALIFORNIA
LATINAS FOR REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE, ACCESS REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE, GENDER JUSTICE. LA. IF,
WHEN, HOW? LAWYERING FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE. IMMIGRANT
DEFENSE ADVOCATES, NATIONAL
IMMIGRATION LAW CENTER, ORANGE
COUNTY EQUALITY COALITION, TEACH
TRAINING AND EARLY ABORTION FOR
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH CARE. YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION, WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY, AND
TEAM JUSTICE SAN DIEGO IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. WELCOME,
TRACY ROSENBERG FROM OAKLAND,
PRIVACY IN OPPOSITION AND ON
BEHALF OF AS WELL, SAN FRANCISCO
BLACK AND JEWISH UNITY COALITION
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN-ISLAMIC
RELATIONS, CALIFORNIA, ALL
FAMILY LEGAL ALLIANCE, SAN DIEGO
ASIAN LAW ALLIANCE, UNIVERSIDAD,
POPULAR HEALTH CARE FOR US,
INDIVISIBLE, CALIFORNIA STATE,
STRONG ADVOCACY FOR PRINCIPLED
ACTION IN GOVERNMENT CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
JUSTICE, UC IRVINE. FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND THE SAN DIEGO
FACULTY ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISSED ONE. ALL RIGHT.
NEXT MORNING, MEMBERS STEVE
MEINRATH, CITIZEN OF SACRAMENTO,
URGING A NO VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. HELLO, DANNY
KENDALL KAISER EXPRESSING
OPPOSITION ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC PRIVACY INFORMATION
CENTER IN C  JUSTICE
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY
OVERSIGHT PROJECT, TECH EQUITY
ACTION FIGHT FOR THE FUTURE,
AMERICAN ATHEISTS INDIVIDUAL,
EAST BAY. FOOD EMPOWERMENT
PROJECT, FREE SPEECH COALITION,
ORGANIZATION FOR IDENTITY AND
CULTURE DEVELOPMENT, POSITIVE
WOMEN'S NETWORK USA, AS WELL AS
THE PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LEO, ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION,
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE BLACK
LIVES MATTER, CALIFORNIA LA
DEFENSA ORGANIZING GROUP ROOTED
IN ABOLITION, LIBERATION AND
EMPOWERMENT POWER OF OUR BAY
AREA STUDENTS DESERVED A
SIDEWALK PROJECT. SANTA MONICA
DEMOCRATIC CLUB SECURE JUSTICE,
SILICON VALLEY DEBUG CANCEL THE
CONTRACT AB INDIVISIBLE, YOLO
AND CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. OMAR AL-TAMIMI FROM THE
COUNCIL OF AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS, CALIFORNIA,
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. LETICIA REYES, ON
BEHALF. OF CALIFORNIA LATINAS
FOR REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE. IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. PULLING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE, QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, CONCERNS. SENATOR
DURAZO. YES. JUST A QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR, I KNOW YOUR HISTORY.
I KNOW WHAT YOU HOW YOU VOTE ON
VERY IMPORTANT PRIVACY ISSUES,
CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUES,
INCARCERATED PEOPLE'S ISSUES, SO
I YOU SHOULD BE PROUD OF THAT
RECORD, ON THIS ISSUE, HOW DO
YOU RESPOND TO THE QUESTION, THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP
BY BY THE OPPOSITION AND, I
GUESS MAYBE CLARIFY FOR ME, THIS
IS A VERY LIMITED USE, AND WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND WHAT ARE THE
GUARDRAILS AND PROTECTIONS
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO HAVE? I THINK
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION. LET ME
JUST START OFF WITH THE CONTEXT.
SO AS OF RIGHT NOW, THERE ARE NO
REGULATIONS FOR FACIAL
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE OUTSIDE OF
LOCAL CITIES. MY LOCAL CITY, I
BELIEVE IT'S BERKELEY. I THINK
THERE ARE SOME OTHER CITIES THAT
HAVE REGULATION ON FACIAL
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE. OUTSIDE OF
THAT, AS A STATE, THERE IS NO
RECOGNITION. YOU KNOW,
REGULATION. SO ALL THE ISSUES
THAT THE WITNESSES WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT, THEY CAN OCCUR
AS WE SPEAK RIGHT NOW, THERE ARE
NO GUARDRAILS. I DID A BILL LAST
YEAR THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
PROBABLY THE MOST ROBUST
GUIDELINES, REGULATIONS,
PREVENTING GUARDRAILS ON FACIAL
RECOGNITION, SOFTWARE WITHIN LAW
ENFORCEMENT, THE SAME COALITION
THAT STANDS OPPOSED TODAY
OPPOSED IT EQUALLY AS
VOCIFEROUSLY. AND IT PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE BEEN THE, MOST
STRINGENT REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY, THE
COALITION, AS FORMED ONLY WANTS
ONE THING, WHICH IS TO BAN
FACIAL RECOGNITION SOFTWARE. I
SUPPORT A BAN. WHEN ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES CARRIED THE SAME
BILL, I CARRIED A NUMBER OF LAST
YEAR, I SUPPORTED IT. SO I DON'T
HAVE ANY PERSONAL ISSUE. WHAT I
DO BELIEVE IS THAT THE BILL,
THAT A BAN WOULDN'T GET THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR. SO WE'RE LEFT WITH
SHOULD WE DO NOTHING OR SHOULD
WE GO DO SOMETHING? SO THIS BILL
IS A FIRST STEP. SO EXACTLY THE
FIRST WITNESS TALKED ABOUT
MISIDENTIFICATION. THIS IS
EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
RIGHT. SO YOU CAN'T HAVE A
WARRANT. YOU CAN'T DO A SEARCH.
YOU CAN'T DO AN ARREST BASED
SOLELY ON THAT FACIAL
RECOGNITION MATCH. THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO STOP, WE HAD A
LOT MORE IN THE BILL LAST YEAR
THAT WE TRIED TO GET THROUGH
AGAIN, OPPOSITION WAS JUST AS
VOCIFEROUS AGAINST THAT, THIS,
TO ME, IS A FIRST STEP TO ME.
THIS IS SOMETHING I WANT TO DO
IN MY LAST YEAR, BECAUSE I WANT
TO HAVE A FIRST STEP IN REALLY
REGULATING, FACIAL RECOGNITION.
THESE CONCERNS ABOUT THE USE OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION. LET ME JUST
REITERATE, FACIAL RECOGNITION
CAN BE USED TODAY. THE SECOND
ANYBODY ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY COULD GO USE IT RIGHT
NOW, THEY DON'T NEED OUR
PERMISSION. THEY DON'T NEED OUR,
OUR, PERMISSION OR OUR GUIDANCE.
ANYTHING THEY COULD GO DO RIGHT
NOW, THIS IS A FIRST STEP TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE FACIAL
RECOGNITION MATCH IS NOT THE
SOLE BASIS FOR WARRANTS, ARRESTS
AND SEARCHES. SO THAT IS A FIRST
STEP. I, I WISH IT WAS MORE MY
LAST YEAR'S BILL WAS MUCH, MUCH
MORE, UNFORTUNATELY, OPPOSITION
WAS JUST AS OPPOSED TO THAT BILL
AS WELL. I SEE THAT THE ACLU
WANTS TO WEIGH IN. SO WE'LL GIVE
YOU A MINUTE. GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU, I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S INTENTION WITH THIS
BILL. I THINK IT IS WORTH NOTING
THAT IN EVERY SINGLE KNOWN CASE
WHERE FACIAL RECOGNITION LED TO
A WRONGFUL ARREST, POLICE DID
NOT RELY ON IT AS THE SOLE
BASIS, IN MR. WILLIAMS CASE,
THEY USED A PHOTO SIX PACK
LINEUP IN MR. OLIVER'S CASE,
THEY USED A PHOTO LINEUP AND
MISS WOODRUFF'S CASE. THEY ALSO
USED A PHOTO LINEUP IN MR. PARKS
CASE. AND MR. REED'S CASE. THEY
ALSO, INSTEAD OF A PHOTO LINEUP,
THEY DID A 1 TO 1 COMPARISON
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. I THINK
IT'S ALSO WORTH NOTING THAT
WHILE THE AUTHOR IS CORRECT THAT
THERE IS CURRENTLY NO STATEWIDE
LAW ON FACIAL RECOGNITION, THIS
BILL WOULD INTRODUCE SEVERAL
HARMS THAT DO NOT EXIST UNDER
THE STATUS QUO. THE FIRST IS
THAT IT WOULD OPEN UP DATA STATE
DATABASES TO PERPETUAL VIRTUAL
LINEUPS. UNDER CURRENT LAW,
THESE DATABASES CANNOT BE USED
IN THIS WAY, BUT BECAUSE OF THE
DEFINITION OF REFERENCE PHOTO
DATABASE AS A DATABASE POPULATED
WITH PHOTOGRAPHS FROM DATABASES
COMPOSED OF DRIVER'S LICENSE AND
OTHER DOCUMENTS MADE OR ISSUED
UNDER THE AUTHORITY OF THE
STATE, A POLITICAL SUBDIVISION
THEREOF, OR ANY OTHER STATE OR A
FEDERAL AGENCY. AMONG OTHER
PROBLEMATIC DATA DATABASES. IT'S
EXPLICITLY OPENING UP STATE
DATABASES FOR BIOMETRIC
SURVEILLANCE, WHICH IS CURRENTLY
PROHIBITED. ADDITIONALLY, IF YOU
LOOK AT THE LETTER FROM THE
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS FROM MORE THAN
HALF OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
WRONGFULLY ARRESTED THAT WE ARE
AWARE OF, THEY ARGUE IN THEIR
LETTER THAT THIS BILL WOULD MAKE
IT HARDER FOR THEM TO CHALLENGE
FACIAL RECOGNITION IN COURT FOR
WRONGFUL ARRESTS. IT WOULD
UNDERMINE THE ABILITY OF OTHER
OF ATTORNEYS IN CALIFORNIA TO
USE THE LEGAL THEORIES THAT
THESE ATTORNEYS RELIED ON IN
THEIR CASES, CHALLENGING
OFFICERS USE OF INVESTIGATIVE,
INVESTIGATIVE TECHNIQUES TAINTED
BY THE INITIAL PHÐ MISMATCH AND
OFFICERS FAILURES TO DISCLOSE
THE DETAILS OF THEIR FLAWED
INVESTIGATIONS TO COURTS AND
PROSECUTORS. SO, IN ADDITION TO
KNOWING THAT IT'S NOT PROVIDING
ANY PROTECTION, IT'S PROVIDING
TWO REAL HARMS THAT ARE NOT IN
CURRENT LAW. ADDITIONALLY, BY
BEING SILENT ON ALL THE OTHER
HARMS OF FRT AND THE WAY THAT
IT'S MISUSED, AB 1814 IMPLIES
THAT THE LEGISLATURE BELIEVES
USING FRT AS THE SOLE BASIS FOR
PROBABLE CAUSE IS THE ONLY RISK
OF FT, THEREBY GIVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AN IMPLICIT PASS AT
MANY OTHER PROBLEMATIC WAYS OF
USING FRT, SUCH AS TO SURVEIL
PEOPLE ENTERING AN ABORTION OR
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE CLINIC, OR
PROTESTERS TO DETERMINE
SOMEONE'S SEXUAL ORIENTATION,
WHICH STANFORD RESEARCH CLAIM IS
POSSIBLE WITH FRT. NONE OF THESE
ARE ALSO ADDRESSED BY THE BILL.
WE RECOGNIZE THE BILL IS
NARROWER THAN LAST YEAR'S BILL.
LAST YEAR'S BILL WOULD HAVE DONE
THINGS LIKE EXPLICITLY AUTHORIZE
REAL TIME FACE SURVEILLANCE AND
MASS SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS. IT
WAS ALSO NOT AS ROBUST AS
FEDERALLY PROPOSED LAWS AROUND
FACIAL RECOGNITION. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS? OH, I'M
SORRY, SENATOR LAIRD. OH, I WAS
ONLY IN YOUR DIRECT LINE OF
SIGHT, SO I WAS LOOKING AT
SENATOR D'ARAZZO. SORRY. GOOD
MOVE. PRETTIER, PRETTIER THAT
COULD. TALKING ABOUT THAT COULD
DELAY THE HEARING. SO I'M GOING
TO, A COMMENT AND A QUESTION,
AND THE COMMENT IS, IS I GET THE
SITUATION. WE'RE IN BECAUSE EVEN
THOUGH THE OPPOSING WITNESS AT
TIMES WAS SHAKING HER HEAD TO
THINGS, YOU YOU SAID THAT EXCEPT
FOR THE CITIES, THERE IS NO
REGULATION THAT THAT DO THIS.
THERE IS NO REGULATION. AND THIS
IN SOME WAYS NEEDS TO BE
MEASURED AGAINST, DOING
REGULATION AGAINST NO
REGULATION. CORRECT. AND YET,
FOR THOSE OF US THAT ARE GOING
TO VOTE ON THIS BILL, IT IS AN
IMPERFECT BILL. AND THERE ARE
CERTAIN THINGS, FOR EXAMPLE, AND
NOW I READ A BUNCH ON THIS, AND
THERE WAS ONE PLACE THAT IT SAID
THAT AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN WERE
MISIDENTIFIED, SOME LARGE
PERCENT OF THE TIME, 35% OF THE
TIME. SO IF WHY NOT TAKE AN
AMENDMENT THAT SAYS THERE SHOULD
BE AN AUDIT OF SORT OF THE
ETHNICITY OF PEOPLE IDENTIFIED
AND OTHER THINGS TO DETERMINE IF
THERE'S A TREND HERE THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED. YEAH
OPPOSITION'S NEVER PRESENTED,
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD REMOVE
THEIR OPPOSITION, BUT WHY NOT?
YOU AFFIRMATIVELY DO IT
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY
REMOVE THE OPPOSITION, BECAUSE
IT'S AN Þ. THAT'S WHAT WE TRIED
TO DO. THE LAST BILL. OKAY,
WELL, IT'S STILL I BELIEVE THIS
IS, THIS IS, YOU KNOW, FOUR
YEARS OF WORK ON THIS ISSUE. NO,
I GET IT. AND YOU'VE BEEN IN THE
TRENCHES AND WHAT SOMEBODY DID
THREE YEARS AGO INFLUENCES YOU.
BUT I'M LOOKING AT THIS NOW AS A
STANDALONE BILL AND FEELING LIKE
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED. THE OTHER THING
IS, IS WHY NOT THERE? THERE WERE
A COUPLE OF INSTANCES. THERE WAS
ONE OF A COUPLE WHERE SOMEBODY
SUDDENLY BECAME A SUSPECT FOR
SOMETHING THAT THEY DIDN'T FEEL
LIKE THEY WERE EVEN INVOLVED IN.
THEY COULDN'T FIGURE OUT WHY
THEY WENT, AND THEY HIRED AN
ATTORNEY. WHY NOT HAVE A
NOTIFICATION THAT IF THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS BEING USED TO LEAD
TO SOMEBODY BEING A SUSPECT,
THAT THEY ARE NOTIFIED OF THAT
SO THAT THEY UNDERSTAND WHY, IF
THEY'RE NOT IN A CASE WHERE THEY
MIGHT HAVE DONE SOMETHING, WHY
SUDDENLY THEY ARE BEING NAMED A
SUSPECT. I MEAN, AGAIN, MANY OF
THESE ISSUES WE DEALT WITH IN
LAST YEAR'S BILL THAT OPPOSITION
WAS EQUALLY OPPOSED TO THIS IS
WHAT WE FELT LIKE WE COULD GET
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE THIS
YEAR. SO IT'S A FIRST STEP. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS ON
NEXT YEAR. I WOULD BE FULLY IN
SUPPORT OF YOU. NOT THAT MUCH
ALCOHOL IN THE UNIVERSE. YES,
BUT I'M JUST SAYING, IF YOU I
WOULD, I WOULD HAPPILY GIVE YOU
ALL MY PAPERS ON THIS IN FRONT
OF A REPRESENTATIVE ISSUE.
POLICE CHIEFS, BUT, IT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT IT STILL DOESN'T NEED
TO GET ADDRESSED. I AGREE, I
AGREE, FIRST, I HAVE YET TO
AUTHOR OR COMPLETE A PERFECT
BILL. I'M STILL TRYING, BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF I'LL DO IT THIS
YEAR. SECOND AGAIN, LIKE I SAID,
THIS IS A FIRST STEP. AND RIGHT
NOW, MANY OF THE THINGS THE
FIRST WITNESS TALKED ABOUT WILL
HOPEFULLY BE HELPED BY MAKING
SURE THAT FACIAL RECOGNITION IS
NOT A FIRST MATCH. THE WITNESS
FROM THE ACLU, MANY I BELIEVE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS ALL THE CASES
THAT SHE CITED, NONE OF THEM
WERE IN CALIFORNIA. ALSO,
THERE'S NOTHING REGARDING STATE
DATABASES IN THIS BILL, AGAIN, I
KNOW THAT THERE IS, YOU KNOW,
REGARDING THE OTHER LINEUPS, I
BELIEVE THAT WAS A BILL THAT WAS
USED THAT WAS USED LAST YEAR TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE AROUND
LINEUPS. SO AGAIN, THIS BILL
DOES NOT SOLVE ALL THE PROBLEMS
WITHIN PUBLIC SAFETY. I GUESS,
SINCE IT'S WHERE IT IS. AND THIS
APPEARS TO BE WHERE IT'S GOING
TO BE, AND WE WILL HAVE TO VOTE
ON IT ON THIS IS YOUR STATEMENT
THAT IT'S A FIRST STEP.
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE'S
IMPERFECTIONS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED. IF THIS BILL PASSES
AND IS SIGNED INTO LAW, I
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS BILL IS A
FIRST STEP, AND THERE ARE MANY
STEPS THAT I HOPE WILL FOLLOW.
AND THAT AS ALL MY BILLS, EVERY
BILL THAT I PRESENT TO THE
GOVERNOR, NONE OF THEM HAVE BEEN
PERFECT. MOVE THE BILL. THANKS,
MR. BUT SORRY, BUT LET ME SAY
THIS IF YOU HAVE SPECIFIC
AMENDMENTS YOU WANT TO PROPOSE
TO ME, I AM ALL OPEN. I'M OPEN.
OKAY. THANK YOU. THE CHAIR GAVE
ME A BILL GOAL TO GET THROUGH
WHILE HE'S GONE. AND WE ARE
DEFINITELY NOT GOING TO HIT THAT
GOAL TODAY. I ACTUALLY I'VE GOT
A I'VE GOT A COUPLE. SO BACK IN
2019 I'M GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT, BUT IN 2019 I
SUPPORTED YOUR DELAY BECAUSE IF
YOU RECALL, SAC BEE DID AN
EXPOSÉ AND I THINK THERE WAS 14
OF OUR COLLEAGUES, INCLUDING
SENATE REPUBLICAN LEADER BRIAN
JONES, THAT WERE IDENTIFIED AS A
CRIMINAL AND ME AS WELL. YEAH,
WELL, YOU MIGHT BE, I DON'T
KNOW. BUT, BRIAN JONES IS
DEFINITELY NOT. I'M ONLY
KIDDING. I'M ONLY KIDDING. SO HE
HAS THE TECHNOLOGY IMPROVED
SINCE THEN? YEAH. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS I'LL LET THE
WITNESS ANSWER THAT. YEAH, I'LL
JUST SAY THAT THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF STANDARDS AND
TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN. SORRY. THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF STANDARDS
AND TECHNOLOGY AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL HAS BEEN RESEARCHING AND
ANALYZING FACIAL RECOGNITION FOR
DECADES. OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS, IT HAS ADVANCED
SIGNIFICANTLY AS ALL TECHNOLOGY
GROWS EXPONENTIALLY. THE LATEST
STUDIES THAT CAME OUT USING, THE
BEST ALGORITHMS, WHICH IS WHAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS USING, WHICH
WAS ACTUALLY ALSO IN OUR PRIOR
BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
USING THOSE HIGHER STANDARDS.
YOU DON'T SEE THE TYPE OF,
BIASES AND OUTCOMES BETWEEN
RACE, BETWEEN GENDERS. THE STUDY
THAT WAS DONE YEARS AGO WAS ALSO
DONE AT A LOWER ALGORITHM. IT'S
NOT THE ALGORITHM THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT USES. SO IT DID, YOU
KNOW, I THINK, GROSSLY
MISIDENTIFIED MEMBERS OF THIS
BODY AND HAS, YOU KNOW, ACROSS
THE BOARD THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER
STUDIES THAT HAVEN'T BEEN QUITE
COMPARABLE TO WHAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S USING NOW AND THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S BEEN USING
RIGHT NOW. AND THEN A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION, PROBABLY FOR YOU, WHEN
. SO WHEN DOES LAW ENFORCEMENT
USE FACIAL TECH TECHNOLOGY IN
THE INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS?
THEY'LL USE IT TO TRY AND NARROW
DOWN TO A THEY DON'T OPEN WITH
THAT. THEY USE IT LATER. THEY
USE IT IN THE IN THE EARLIER
STAGES TO NARROW DOWN TO
POTENTIAL SUSPECTS. AND THEN IT
HAS IT'S INCUMBENT UPON THEM TO
DEVELOP SPECIFIC EVIDENCE,
SEPARATE FROM THE FACIAL
RECOGNITION MATCH, TO ACTUALLY
DEVELOP THE NECESSARY COMPONENTS
FOR PROBABLE CAUSE FOR EITHER A
SEARCH OR AN ARREST. I'M GOING
TO GIVE YOU ONE MINUTE BECAUSE I
APPRECIATE IT. NO I AM, AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I JUST WANT
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
ACCURACIES. RECENT TESTING BY
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
STANDARDS AND TECHNOLOGY, OR
NIST, AS WELL AS BY ACADEMIC
RESEARCHERS, SHOW THAT RACIAL
AND GENDER DISPARITIES IN FRT
MISMATCH RATES STILL EXIST.
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S NO LAB TEST
THAT REFLECTS HOW POLICE USE FIT
IN THE REAL WORLD. LABS DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO EXACT REFERENCE
PHOTO DATABASES THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT USES, AND TESTS
CAN'T ACCOUNT FOR THE LOW
QUALITY IMAGES FROM SURVEILLANCE
CAMERAS THAT POLICE RUN THROUGH
FRT. LET ALONE THE TIMES WHEN
POLICE HAVE USED DNA GENERATED
MODELS OF FACES TO RUN THROUGH.
FRC TESTS ALSO CAN ACCOUNT FOR
AUTOMATION BIAS, WHICH CAUSES
EVEN EXPERTS TO THINK THE
COMPUTER IS SMARTER THAN THEM
AND THEREFORE TRUST WHAT ARE
CLEARLY MISMATCHES, SUCH AS IN
THE CASE OF MR. OLIVER, WHO WAS
ARRESTED AFTER BEING MIS MATCHED
TO A SUSPECT WITH NO FACIAL OR
ARM TATTOOS. DESPITE MR. OLIVER
HAVING EXTENSIVE TATTOOS, IT
WASN'T CAUGHT UNTIL IT WAS
BEFORE THE JUDGE. LAB TESTS CAN
ALSO BE MISLEADING BECAUSE OF
THE VERY NATURE OF WHAT IS BEING
TESTED. NIST TESTS FOR OVERALL
POSITIVE RATES. WE'RE AT WE'RE
AT WE'RE AT. OKAY, LET ME JUST
REALLY QUICKLY SAY THAT SOME OF
THESE TESTS SHOW THAT THE
DISPARITIES ARE AS MUCH AS 100
TIMES HIGHER FOR CERTAIN BLACK
WOMEN THAN FOR WHITE MEN. TO
THIS DAY, INCLUDING ON TESTS
THAT LOOK LIKE THEY ARE SCORING
99% ON THIS TEST. AND THESE ARE,
FRC ALGORITHMS THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS USING. THE
ALGORITHMS ARE STILL INACCURATE.
OKAY, GREAT. SO VERY ROBUST
DISCUSSION. WE HAVE A MOTION YOU
MAY CLOSE I WOULD JUST SAY ALL
THOSE ISSUES THAT, OPPOSITION
OUTLINED LAST YEAR WERE
ADDRESSED IN MY LAST YEAR'S
BILL, WHICH THEY OPPOSED EQUALLY
AS VOCIFEROUSLY, AS I MENTIONED
TO THE OTHER SENATORS, THIS IS A
FIRST STEP. RIGHT NOW, YOU HAVE
NO REGULATION. SO IF YOU WANT TO
CONTINUE ALL THE THINGS,
ESPECIALLY AROUND
MISIDENTIFICATION, THAT PEOPLE
SAID THAT THEY ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT, THIS IS A FIRST STEP. IT
DEFINITELY SHOULD NOT BE THE
LAST STEP, BUT THIS IS THE FIRST
STEP THAT WE'RE PRESENTING YOU
TODAY. AND, WE'LL HOPE THAT
PERHAPS ONE OF THE DISTINGUISHED
SENATORS WILL CONTINUE THIS WORK
NEXT YEAR. WITH THAT RESPECT FOR
AI VOTE ON AB 1814. THANK YOU
FOR THAT. AND WITH THAT
SECRETARY, CALL THE ROLL. THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB 1814.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. BERG WILK Ã
WILK. AYE. ALLEN ASHBY.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE. LAIRD
LAIRD. AYE. NEIL. NEIL. AYE
ROTH. ROTH. AYE. STERN WAHAB. 6
TO 0. 6 TO 0. AND WE'LL LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
HE'S PRESENTING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RECORDS. AND WHAT ITEM IS THAT?
OKAY I AM READY FOR A FIGHT.
OKAY. UP NEXT IS FILE ITEM 13 AB
2696 BY SPEAKER EMERITUS RENDON.
BUT BEING PRESENTING TODAY IS
ASSEMBLYMAN KING. SO WITH THAT,
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY, YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2696
ON BEHALF OF SPEAKER MÁS RENDON,
AB 2696 CLOSES A LOOPHOLE THAT
ALLOWS GENERAL CONTRACTORS TO
AVOID WAGE LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN
THEY COMPLETE PROJECTS WITH
THEIR OWN PERSONNEL RATHER THAN
SUBCONTRACTING. WE HAVE TWO
GREAT WITNESSES DANNY CURTIN,
DIRECTOR, AS WELL AS PATTY
MCCARRON, DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE
OF CARPENTERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR PRESENTING THE BILL,
ASSEMBLYMAN. OKAY OKAY. ALL
GOOD. ALL RIGHT. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. WHENEVER IT COMES DOWN,
I DO WANT TO SAY, THIS IS
ANOTHER WORK IN PROGRESS, MAYBE
A LITTLE LESS COMPLEX THAN THE
LAST ONE. AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL
GET THE BALL ROLLING BACK ON
TRACK. THIS PASSED 69 TO NOTHING
IN THE ASSEMBLY. IT'S BASICALLY
DOESN'T CHANGE THE LAW AT ALL,
BUT ALLOWS AN EXISTING JOINT
LIABILITY AND LIABILITY FOR
GENERAL CONTRACTORS. IT ALLOWS
OUR JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS TO BE TO HAVE STANDING
IN WAGE LAW VIOLATIONS. WE SPENT
SOME TIME DEVELOPING JOINT
LIABILITY BETWEEN GENERAL
CONTRACTOR AND THEIR VIOLATIONS
OF THEIR SUBS. BUT SOMEHOW WE
DID NOT ATTACH OUR STANDING FOR
THE JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS ON THE GENERAL
CONTRACTOR. IF THEY VIOLATE THE
LAW WITH THEIR OWN WORKERS.
PATTY MCCARRON IS THE DIRECTOR
OF OPERATIONS FOR OUR
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA, IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS, BUT SHE'LL BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER THOSE. SO HOPEFULLY WE
CAN. ANY QUESTIONS? PATTY, DO
YOU HAVE ANY DO WE HAVE ANY
ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT TO
OFFER ME TWO TESTIMONY OR DID
YOU WANT TO TALK OR ARE YOU JUST
HERE FOR TECHNICAL? I CAN WELL,
I'M IN SUPPORT OF IT. RIGHT. BUT
I AM IN SUPPORT OF I'M SORRY I
WAS UNDER. DO YOU WANT TO
TESTIFY OR THOUGHT YOU WERE HERE
JUST FOR TECHNICAL. WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO, WHATEVER YOU WOULD
LIKE. OH, WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
DO. THIS IS DEMOCRACY. YOU MAY
DO WHATEVER YOU WANT. OKAY.
THANK YOU, MY NAME IS PATTY
MCCARRON, AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF OPERATIONS FOR THE CARPENTERS
CONTRACTORS COOPERATION
COMMITTEE, A JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE, WE HAVE
BEEN UTILIZING AB 1701 AND 727
TO ASSIST WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN
VICTIMS OF WAGE THEFT BY
UNSCRUPULOUS CONTRACTORS, IT'S
BEEN WORKING VERY WELL, OUR
REPRESENTATIVES TO INVESTIGATE
WAGE THEFT HAVE FOUND THAT
GENERAL CONTRACTORS ARE
CIRCUMVENTING THE LAW BY SELF
PERFORMING THE WORK. AND THESE
PROJECTS INCLUDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, MIXED USE, AMONG
OTHERS. IN THESE CASES, WE HAVE
NO STANDING TO HELP THESE
WORKERS RECOVER THEIR MONIES AND
THEIR, THEIR THESE LOW WAGE
WORKERS RECOVER THEIR WAGES. AND
WE'RE ASKING FOR A YES VOTE,
THANK YOU. AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HAVE A MOTION. OKAY. ANYBODY
ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT? SEEING
NONE. ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? YOU CAN DO IT FROM
THE MIC. OR YOU CAN COME AND
JOIN US UP FRONT. NIELSEN
MERKSAMER ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY. THANK YOU.
OKAY. NOT COMING UP HERE. OKAY.
WITH THAT, WE'LL PULL IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. DO YOU HAVE A
MOTION? A MOTION QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, CONCERNS, SEEING NONE.
LET'S CALL THE ROLL. OH. I'M
SORRY. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, I'M
FEELING THE STRESS BECAUSE I
HAVE NOT HIT MY GOALS TODAY. I'M
MOTORING WITH YOU. I'M HERE TO
HELP. I THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
13. AB 2696. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
UMBERG WILK NOT VOTING. ALLEN
ASHBY. CABALLERO. CABALLERO. I
Dð RUSSELL TO RUSSELL I LAIRD.
LAIRD I NILO. NILO I ROTH. ROTH
I STERN. WAHAB 5 TO 0 5 TO 0.
WE'LL HOLD THAT FOR HOLD THAT
OPEN FOR PEOPLE TO ADD ON. NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM. 14 AB
2754. AGAIN BY, SPEAKER EMERITUS
RENDON BEING PRESENTED BY
ASSEMBLYMAN TING. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY, YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AB 2754
WILL PROVIDE GREATER EMPLOYMENT
PROTECTION TO PART TO PORT.
EXCUSE ME. NOT PART PORT.
DRAYAGE TRUCK DRIVERS ACROSS THE
STATE BY ENSURING COMPANIES THAT
CONTRACT WITH THEM ARE HELD
LIABLE FOR ANY VIOLATIONS OF
LABOR LAW. WE'RE HERE TO HAVE WE
HAVE SHANE GUZMAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL AND SUPPORT. MR.
CHAIRMAN, MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
SHANE GUZMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL, WE ARE THE
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS BILL, WE
HAVE SPONSORED AND SUPPORTED A
NUMBER OF MEASURES IN THIS AREA
TO GET AT A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM
THAT'S PLAGUED PORT DRAYAGE
DRIVERS FOR DECADES, ACTUALLY,
SINCE WE HAD TRUCKING
DEREGULATION IN THE 19 EARLY
1980S, IT'S MISCLASSIFICATION
THE THOSE DRIVERS AREN'T
PROTECTED LIKE OTHER EMPLOYEES,
WITH RESPECT TO WAGES, HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF WAGES
HAVE BEEN ROBBED FROM THESE
WORKERS OVER THOSE DECADES. THEY
DON'T GET INJURY PROTECTION
THROUGH WORKERS COMP
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE, ETC. SO
WHAT THIS BILL IS REALLY
DESIGNED TO DO IS TO LOOK AT
PORT DRAYAGE TRUCKING, LIKE WE
DO WITH OTHER INDUSTRIES THAT
HAVE A LOT OF WORKER
EXPLOITATION, LIKE JANITORIAL,
WAREHOUSE, ETC. AND WE JUST
SIMPLY ADD, PORT DRAINAGE,
TRUCKING TO THOSE LAWS THAT
REALLY GET AT, DO WE HAVE A
MINIMUM CONTRACT THAT WILL ALLOW
THE, THE TRUCK TRUCKING COMPANY
TO COMPLY WITH ITS LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE LAW AND
THEN LASTLY, WE ADD ON TO AN
EXISTING JOINT LIABILITY LAW TO
STRENGTHEN IT FOR PORT DRAYAGE
DRIVERS, WE HAVE WORKED VERY
HARD WITH THE OPPONENTS, OVER
THE WHOLE TIME THIS BILL HAS
BEEN IN PRINT. WE HAVE MANAGED
TO GET THE TAKE AMENDMENTS TO
GET THE TRUCKING ASSOCIATION,
THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION TO NEUTRAL AND OTHER
OPPONENTS TO NEUTRAL. AND WE
CERTAINLY WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH OTHERS WHO HAVE CONCERNS
AND ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. OKAY.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION.
ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT?
GOOD AFTERNOON. YVONNE FERNANDES
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF LA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DO WE HAVE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES
HERE IN OPPOSITION SEEING NONE
ANY ME TO TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION, SEEING NONE. PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. WE DO
HAVE A MOTION. QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, CONCERNS, SEEING NONE.
LET'S CALL THE ROLL GETS A
CLOSE. OH YEAH. YOU MAY KEEP.
SORRY ABOUT THAT. I'LL USE THE
SENATOR'S COMMENTS AS MY CLOSE.
IT'S NOT YOU, IT'S ME. JEEZ. OUR
CHAIR IS ON A MISSION. YEAH.
THANK YOU. OKAY, THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER 14, AB 2754. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG WILK NOT
VOTING. ALLEN ASHBY. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. I DURAZO RUSSELL I
LAIRD. LAIRD I NILO. NO MELO.
NO. ROTH. ROTH I. STERN. WAHAB
YOU HAVE 4 TO 1, 4 TO 1. WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO
ADD ON. AND I SEE OUR NEXT
AUTHOR'S HERE. AND WE'RE GOING
TO RUN THE TABLE RIGHT. WELL HAT
TRICK IS THREE. I SEE YOU HAVE
FOUR. I HAVE FOUR. THERE'S ONE
ON CONSENT I ONE ON CONSENT. OH
THAT'S AN EASY ONE. I SEE FOUR,
BUT I COULD BE WRONG. YOU PANIC
ABOUT THE ONE ON HIS FILE. ITEM
16 AB. YOU WANT TO GO IN FILE
ORDER? IS THAT YOUR PREFERENCE?
OKAY, SO AB 2050 HERE. SO. AND
THE RECOMMENDATION IS IT'S JUST
A BUSINESS Ó JUST A Dð PASS.
LOVE THOSE WITH THAT. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY YOU MAY START.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND SENATORS IN
A STATE WITH STATEWIDE MAILED
BALLOTS, THE ACCURACY OF OUR
VOTER RECORDS IS OF PARAMOUNT
IMPORTANCE. THE ELECTRONIC
REGISTRATION INFORMATION CENTER,
KNOWN AS ERIC, IS A POWERFUL
TOOL. ELECTIONS OFFICIALS CAN
USE TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
MOST UP TO DATE VOTER ROLLS.
ERIC IS A NONPARTISAN NONPROFIT
GOVERNED BY ITS MEMBER STATES
THAT MUTUALLY AGREED TO SHARE
DATA, SUCH AS VOTER REGISTRATION
AND VEHICLE LICENSING DATA IN
ORDER TO KEEP THEIR VOTER ROLLS
UPDATED AND TO REACH OUT TO
ELIGIBLE BUT UNREGISTERED
CITIZENS. THE SECRETARY OF STATE
ESTIMATES THAT THERE ARE 4.7
MILLION UNREGISTERED ELIGIBLE
VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA THAT IS
GREATER THAN THE POPULATION OF
26 STATES. WHEN A VOTER MOVES,
THEY OFTEN REREGISTER TO VOTE IN
THEIR NEW JURISDICTION, BUT DO
NOT NOTIFY THEIR PRIOR COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL THAT THEY
HAVE MOVED. DUE TO THE HIGHLY
MOBILE NATURE OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION, IT IS LIKELY THAT
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF VOTER
REGISTRATION RECORDS THAT ARE
OUT OF DATE DUE TO A RECENT
MOVE. ERIC MEMBERS DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO OTHER MEMBERS DATA OR
REPORTS STORED ON ERIC'S SERVERS
AND STATE VOTER REGISTRATION
SYSTEMS ARE NEVER CONNECTED TO
ERIC. AB 2050 50 AUTHORED STATE
TO JOIN ERIC ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE
THE STATE WITH DATA ON VOTERS
WHO HAVE MOVED IN-STATE, OUT OF
STATE, OR DIED, AS WELL AS
PROVIDING DATA ON CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TO VOTE BUT ARE
NOT REGISTERED. ERIC IS DESIGNED
TO VOTE TO WORK WITHIN THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE NATIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION ACT, UNDER WHICH
STATES CANNOT REMOVE VOTERS FROM
THE ROLLS JUST BECAUSE ERIC
REPORTS THEY HAVE MOVED. BEFORE
REMOVING A VOTER, STATES MUST
CONTACT THE VOTER, SEEK TO
CONFIRM ERIC'S INFORMATION, AND
LEAVE VOTERS ON THE ROLLS FOR AT
LEAST TWO FEDERAL GENERAL
ELECTION CYCLES. AS CONSISTENT
WITH FEDERAL LAW, THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS RAISES ISSUES
CONCERNING THE PRIVACY RIGHTS OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT MAY BE
IMPLICATED. IF ERIC JOINS. IF
CALIFORNIA JOINS ERIC, I AGREE
WITH THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS PRIVACY,
WHICH IS WHY THIS BILL HAS
INCLUDED MANY PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS. SPECIFICALLY, AB
2050 PROHIBITS THE SENDING OF AB
60 LICENSE DATA TO ERIC.
THEREFORE DATA ON NON-CITIZENS
IS NOT SENT TO ERIC. IT REQUIRES
THE SECRETARY OF STATE TO
RECEIVE CERTIFICATION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY, THAT PROPER
CYBERSECURITY PROTECTIONS ARE IN
PLACE IN THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE AND AT ERIC, AND
REQUIRES THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TO CONSULT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY PROTECTION AGENCY WHEN
DEVELOPING REGULATIONS GOVERNING
CALIFORNIA'S PARTICIPATION. IN
ERIC. ADDITIONALLY, ERIC'S
PROCEDURES INCLUDE MANY STEPS TO
PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF
INFORMATION IT RECEIVES,
INCLUDING HASHING, WHICH IS A
ONE WAY ENCRYPTION OF SENSITIVE
DATA BEFORE THAT INFORMATION IS
SENT TO ERIC. FURTHERMORE,
CALIFORNIA'S PARTICIPATION IS
ERIC IS CONSISTENT WITH STATE
LAW GOVERNING THE USE OF VOTER
REGISTRATION DATA, WHICH
PROVIDES FOR THE DATA TO BE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR ELECTION AND
GOVERNMENTAL PURPOSES AS
DETERMINED BY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE. ENSURING THE ACCURACY OF
THE STATE'S VOTER REGISTRATION
ROLLS IS UNQUESTIONABLY A
LEGITIMATE GOVERNMENTAL AND
ELECTION PURPOSE. CALIFORNIA'S
EFFORTS TO INCREASE THE
ACCESSIBILITY OF OUR VOTER
REGISTRATION SYSTEM HAS BEEN A
GREAT SUCCESS. BECOMING AN ERIC
MEMBER IS A NATURAL STEP IN
CALIFORNIA'S MISSION TO IMPROVE
THE ACCESSIBILITY AND EASE OF
VOTING. AB 2050 IS SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTIONS OFFICIALS,
AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ERIC IS SHANE HAMLIN,
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ERIC
AND TRICIA WEBER IN FRONT OF ME,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS. THANK YOU.
WITH THAT, EACH WITNESS GETS TWO
MINUTES. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
YOU GO FIRST, MR. CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS SHANE HAMLIN. I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ERIC, THE
ELECTRONIC REGISTRATION
INFORMATION CENTER. I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF AB 2050. AS YOU
HEARD, ERIC IS A MEMBER LED,
MEMBER FUNDED, NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION GOVERNED BY STATE
ELECTION OFFICIALS, THAT IS THE
ELECTIONS DIRECTORS IN EACH OF
OUR MEMBER STATES WHO, OF
COURSE, REPORT TO THEIR
SECRETARIES OF STATE CAREFULLY
AND SECURELY USING VOTER DATA,
DRIVER DATA, DEATH DATA FROM THE
SOCIAL SECURITY ADMINISTRATION,
AND NATIONAL CHANGE OF ADDRESS
DATA. WE PROVIDE OUR MEMBERS
WITH ACTIONABLE INFORMATION THEY
CAN USE TO BETTER KEEP THEIR
VOTER ROLLS UP TO DATE, REGISTER
NEW VOTERS, AND INVESTIGATE
POSSIBLE CASES OF ILLEGAL VOTING
. IN THIS WAY, WE AID IN
CARRYING OUT A GOVERNMENTAL
FUNCTION, AN ESSENTIAL FUNCTION
IN TERMS OF ELECTION INTEGRITY
AND THE FAIR CONDUCT AND ACCESS
TO ELECTIONS. WE ARE NOT A
COMMERCIAL ENTITY. ERIC HAS
ALWAYS TAKEN DATA PRIVACY AND
SECURITY SERIOUSLY, AND WE
RESPECT AND APPRECIATE
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP IN
ESTABLISHING STRONG PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS, DATA PRIVACY AND
SECURITY ARE BAKED INTO OUR
GOVERNANCE DOCUMENTS AND OUR
TECHNICAL INFRASTRUCTURE, AND IT
INCLUDES MULTIPLE WAYS AND
LAYERS OF SECURITY IN WHICH WE
PROTECT THE DATA. WE HAVE TWO
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES. ONE, YOU
HEARD THE SPONSOR OR SPONSOR
REFERRED TO EARLIER, AND THAT'S
THE ONE WAY HASH. THIS IS
APPLIED TO THE SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS, DATES OF BIRTH AND
DRIVER'S LICENSE NUMBERS. OUR
MEMBERS HASH THOSE VALUES BEFORE
TRANSMITTING THE DATA TO US, AND
THEY ACTUALLY ENCRYPT THE ENTIRE
FILE BEFORE IT'S TRANSMITTED TO
US. AGAIN, HASHING IS DIFFERENT
THAN ENCRYPTION. THERE'S NO
GOING BACK. THERE ARE NO KEYS
FOR THAT. HASHED DATA ARE NOT
SHARED WITH MEMBERS EVEN IN THE
REPORTS THEY RECEIVE, INCLUDING
THAT INCLUDE OTHER STATES DATA.
WE UTILIZE SOC TWO AUDITS SOC
TWO AUDITS ARE THE GOLD STANDARD
USED FOR ASSURING CUSTOMERS AND
MEMBERS THAT YOUR ORGANIZATION
IS PROTECTING THEIR DATA. THREE
QUICK POINTS FROM OUR MEMBERSHIP
AGREEMENT ON PRIVACY. ERIC AND
OUR MEMBERS MUST COMPLY WITH
APPLICABLE FEDERAL LAWS THAT
APPLY TO THE DATA SETS THAT WE
ARE USING, INCLUDING THE FEDERAL
DRIVER'S PRIVACY PROTECTION ACT
AND REGULATIONS ON THE NCOA DATA
AND DEATH DATA. OUR MEMBERS ARE
PROHIBITED FROM USING DATA.
THANK YOU. ALRIGHTY. NEXT
WITNESS. DO I? YES. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS TRICIA
WEBER. I AM THE CO-CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
AND ELECTION OFFICIALS. I'M ALSO
THE COUNTY CLERK AND REGISTRAR
OF VOTERS FOR SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS
BILL. COUNTY OFFICIALS WANT TO
MAINTAIN THE BEST VOTER RECORDS
THEY POSSIBLY CAN. AND THIS
USING ERIC, IS ONE MORE TOOL
THAT WE CAN USE IN ORDER TO KEEP
THOSE RECORDS CLEAR AND CLEAN
AND SEND OUT TO OUR VOTERS THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED.
RIGHT NOW, WE ALREADY DO THIS
THROUGH THE SNAIL MAIL PROCESS,
WHERE SOMEBODY WILL REGISTER TO
VOTE IN IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY. I
TAKE THEIR PREVIOUS REGISTRATION
AND I SEND IT OUT OF STATE
THROUGH MAIL, OR I SEND IT
THROUGH VOEPEL. IF THEY'RE
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
I RECEIVED LAST WEEK OR THE WEEK
BEFORE, EXCUSE ME, SOMETHING
FROM ANOTHER STATE THAT TOOK
FOUR AND A HALF MONTHS TO GET TO
ME, AND WE FINALLY WERE ABLE TO
NOTIFY THE VOTER. WE RECEIVED
THEIR REGISTRATION AND CANCEL
THEM OFF THE RECORDS. SO THIS
WOULD BE A GREAT WAY FOR
COUNTIES TO MAINTAIN A BETTER
VOTER ROLL IN A MORE REAL TIME
SITUATION. AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
ABOUT VOTER ROLL MAINTENANCE. IF
YOU HAVE ANY, AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHTY. THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
2496, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. ALICIA PEREZ FROM
THE OFFICE OF THE CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HOPEFULLY IT'S AB
2050. ANDY BIRNBAUM, ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND
STRONG SUPPORT PARTY, THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS.
TANISHA BOETTNER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. OTHER SUPPORT,
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE, LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
FILE NUMBER 17 AB 2496, PLEASE
APPROACH. YOU MAY TAKE A SEAT AT
THE TABLE OR THE MICROPHONE.
YOUR CHOICE. YEAH. I'M SORRY.
YES YES. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS RUTH DAWSON
WITH ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION. WE
ARE IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
AB 2050, AS THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE CALIFORNIA SECRETARY OF
STATE TO SHARE SENSITIVE DATA
WITH ERIC, WHICH WE BELIEVE IS
IN CONFLICT WITH CALIFORNIA'S
LONG STANDING STRICT PRIVACY
STATUTES AND CONSTITUTIONAL
REQUIREMENTS THAT PROTECT SUCH
DATA. WE APPRECIATE THE
GUARDRAILS THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
ADDED TO THE BILL IN AN ATTEMPT
TO SAFEGUARD CALIFORNIANS
PRIVACY. UNFORTUNATELY, OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT CONFIDENTIALITY
OF PRIVATE INFORMATION AND
PROBLEMATIC ERRORS IN THE ERIC
SYSTEM PERSIST. IN ADDITION,
RECENT PROBLEMS RELATED TO THE
ACCURACY OF ERIC'S DATA SHARING
AND MATCHING PROGRAMS SHOW THAT
VOTERS COULD ERRONEOUSLY BE
FLAGGED FOR REMOVAL FROM THE
VOTER FILE AND WRONGFULLY
DISENFRANCHIZED. ERIC HAS NOT
BEEN INDEPENDENTLY SHOWN TO
INCREASE VOTER REGISTRATION MORE
THAN IT POTENTIALLY ERRONEOUSLY
PURGES VOTERS. AND THAT'S WHY
I'M HERE TODAY. WE WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR
THEIR TIME AND COLLABORATION IN
SEEING WHETHER WE CAN REACH A
MIDDLE GROUND, AND
UNFORTUNATELY, WE JUST HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION ABOUT
WHICH WAY THE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS LANDS HERE AND THUS
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NO
ONE ELSE APPROACHED THE
MICROPHONE. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. SENATOR ROTH,
THEN, SENATOR CABALLERO, THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I
UNDERSTAND THE SAFEGUARDS THAT
THE SYSTEM I GUESS, APPARENTLY
HAS, BUT I'M LOOKING AT PAGE 12
OF THE ANALYSIS, AND THERE'S A
SUGGESTION AS TO AN AMENDMENT TO
ALLOW OPT OUTS, OPT INS. WE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME ON PRIVACY
HERE, AND WE'VE GOT A BUNCH OF
BILLS IN THIS PACKET OF 70 OR 67
OR HOWEVER MANY WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO DEAL WITH BEFORE WE GO
HOME TOMORROW MORNING, AND I'M
JUST WONDERING WHERE WHERE THIS
SUGGESTION FOR AN AMENDMENT
WENT. DID ANYBODY TAKE A LOOK AT
IT? COMMITTEE MADE THE
SUGGESTION, MAYBE A VOTER
DOESN'T WANT TO HAVE THEIR
INFORMATION. IN THIS PROCESS,
WELL, THE LAW ALREADY PROVIDES
FOR THE DATA TO BE USED FOR
ELECTION AND GOVERNMENTAL
PURPOSES, BECAUSE MAINTAINING
THE ACCURACY OF OUR VOTER ROLLS
IS OF THE UTMOST IMPORTANCE. SO,
WHEN VOTERS REGISTER THEIR
THEY'RE BASICALLY SIGNING UP,
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THAT DATA IS CORRECT AND
UPDATED. SHOULD THEY MOVE OUT OF
STATE OR MOVE WITHIN THE STATE.
SO YES, GO AHEAD. BUT I MEAN,
I'M NOT I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE HOW
CLEAR IT IS TO VOTERS WHEN THEY
REGISTER THAT THIS IS WHAT
THEY'RE SIGNING UP FOR. DO YOU?
I BELIEVE THEY DO. THEY I
BELIEVE THAT WHEN VOTERS ARE
REGISTERING TO VOTE, THEY'RE
SIGNING UP AND KNOWING THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ON A VOTER
ROLL AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE
GETTING A BALLOT AND THAT, WE
HAVE A STATEWIDE VOTER
REGISTRATION DATABASE WHERE THE
DATA IS SHARED AMONG STATEWIDE,
RIGHT, RIGHT. THIS IS DOING
SOMETHING ELSE. THIS WILL AND
THEN AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT,
WHEN VOTERS MOVE IN AND OUT OF
STATE, WE'RE A VERY MOBILE STATE
HERE. CALIFORNIA PEOPLE ARE
MOVING IN AND OUT ALL THE TIME.
SO THIS IS A GREAT TOOL FOR US
TO BE USING TO ENSURE THAT, THAT
WE'RE GETTING THAT INFORMATION
AND UPDATING THOSE VOTER RECORDS
SO THEY ARE NOT DISENFRANCHIZED
WHEN THEY DO MOVE. BUT LET ME
TURN THAT OVER JUST A COUPLE OF
POINTS. PERHAPS TO CONSIDER IN
RESPONSE. FIRST, ALL OF MOST OF
THE OTHER MEMBER STATES OF ERIC
INCLUDE INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
MEMBERSHIP IN ERIC PROMINENTLY
ON THEIR VOTER REGISTRATION
PAGES, AND WEBSITES, EITHER
THROUGH THE STATE OR AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL, OR AT BOTH. SO
CITIZENS IN OTHER STATES THAT
ARE MEMBERS OF ERIC DO HAVE
ACCESS TO A KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT
ERIC IS. SECONDLY, I WOULD SAY
THAT ARE WE REQUIRING THAT IN
THE BILL? IT'S NOT REQUIRED, BUT
I SUSPECT THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S WEBSITE ON VOTER
REGISTRATION IS VERY INFORMATIVE
AND INCLUDES A LOT OF
INFORMATION, AND I SUSPECT THAT
THEY WOULD ADD INFORMATION ABOUT
MEMBERSHIP IN ERIC IF AND WHEN
THE STATE JOINS, WE TEND TO BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE CLEAR.
UNDERSTOOD. YEAH. AND THEN
IMPORTANTLY IN THE WAY THAT ERIC
WORKS, PART OF THE REASON WHY
ERIC IS SO EFFECTIVE IS BECAUSE
WE DO COMPARE ALL AVAILABLE
RECORDS AND THE VOTER FILE AND
THE DMV FILE TO IDENTIFY VOTERS
WHO HAVE MOVED OR DIED. AND IF
YOU IF VOTERS CAN OPT OUT OF
THAT, WHICH I UNDERSTAND, THE
DESIRE TO DO THAT AND OFFER
THAT, IT WOULD REDUCE THE
EFFICACY OF THOSE REPORTS BY
EXCLUDING THOSE VOTERS FROM THE
DATA MATCHING PROCESS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN IDENTIFYING
VOTERS WHO'VE MOVED OUT OF STATE
SO THAT YOU CAN REMOVE THEM FROM
YOUR ROLL. SO THEY'RE NO LONGER
RECEIVING BALLOTS BY MAIL. SINCE
YOU MAIL BALLOTS HERE. AND
THERE'S ALSO THE QUESTION OF
WOULD THAT BE RETROACTIVE OR
PROSPECTIVE, YOU KNOW, WOULD THE
SECRETARY OF STATE HAVE TO OFFER
TO ALL 22 MILLION CURRENTLY
REGISTERED VOTERS THE ABILITY TO
OPT OUT OR ONLY TO NEW
REGISTRANTS? I THINK IT ADDS,
ADDS A LOT OF COMPLEXITY AND
COMPLICATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MR. CHAIR. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR CABALLERO, THEN SENATOR
LAIRD, THEN SENATOR RUSSO, I HAD
THE SAME QUESTION. I GUESS THE
THING THAT THAT IS IMPORTANT TO
ME IS THAT THERE BE NOTICE, AND
I GET WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IN
TERMS OF THE OPT IN AND OPT OUT,
IT JUST IT STARTS TO GET A
LITTLE BIT UNWIELDY. BUT I THINK
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW THAT, THAT
THERE THAT IF WE MOVE IN THIS
DIRECTION, WE'RE PART OF A
SYSTEM. AND THAT WHEN YOU MOVE,
YOU'RE REQUIRED TO CHANGE YOUR
REGISTRATION. BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT.
QUITE FRANKLY. I THINK PART OF
THE PROBLEM IS PEOPLE MOVE AND
THEY DON'T THINK ABOUT IT, AND
NOW THAT WE SEND THE BALLOTS TO
THEIR HOUSE, IT'S A DIFFERENT
STORY, RIGHT? BECAUSE YOUR
BALLOT IS GOING SOMEWHERE ELSE.
IF YOU'VE MOVED. AND, AND SO THE
NECESSITY OF ADVISING THE
SECRETARY OF STATE OR YOUR
COUNTY REGISTRAR, REGISTRAR OF
VOTERS IS, IS IMPORTANT AND
THAT, THAT IF YOU MOVE AND YOU
DON'T ADVISE THAT, THERE'S A
PROCESS FOR FIGURING OUT WHERE
YOU WENT AND TRYING TO TAKE YOU
OFF THE ROLLS WHERE YOU LEFT IT
JUST I WOULD FEEL MUCH MORE
COMFORTABLE IF THERE'S A SYSTEM
WHERE WE'RE LETTING VOTERS KNOW,
NOT SURPRISING THEM WITH, GUESS
WHAT, WE'VE DEVELOPED A NEW
SYSTEM, AND YOU'RE YOU'RE IT'S
ONE THING TO SHARE THE
INFORMATION WITHIN THE STATE.
IT'S ANOTHER TO SEND MY
INFORMATION TO TEXAS WHEN I HAVE
NO PLANS ON MOVING OVER THERE OR
WHEREVER IT IS. SO. SO I THINK
THAT ADVISEMENT IS GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
DO YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO THAT
JUST VERY QUICKLY, TECHNICALLY,
TO HELP YOU UNDERSTAND THE RISKS
, YOU'RE ASSESSING YOUR NÓ
CALIFORNIA'S DATA WOULD GET
SHARED WITH ANOTHER STATE UNLESS
THEY MOVED TO THAT OTHER STATE,
JUST TO BE CLEAR. SO CALIFORNIA.
BUT THE WAY THAT YOU FIND OUT IS
YOU SEND THE DATA OUT. SO I'M
JUST SAYING I GET WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING, I JUST THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO AN
EDUCATION PROCESS AND IF YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE AN OPT IN OR
AN OPT OUT, THAT THERE BE PART
OF THE WHOLE PROGRAM, BE AN
EDUCATION PROCESS. SO PEOPLE ARE
NOT SURPRISED AT WHAT THEY MAY
SEE AS INTRUSIVE INFORMATION. I
MEAN, WE STARTED THIS AUTOMATIC
REGISTRATION DOING GETTING YOUR
DRIVER'S LICENSE. AND PEOPLE ARE
STILL SURPRISED AND YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE SURPRISED AND SHOCKED WHEN
THEY FIND OUT THAT NOW THEY'RE
REGISTERED TO VOTE. THAT IS PART
OF AN EDUCATION, SHOULD BE PART
OF AN EDUCATION PROCESS. AND I'M
SURE OUR ELECTIONS OFFICIALS AND
OUR SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
WILL WANT TO MAKE SURE VOTERS
ARE INFORMED OF THIS, THIS TOOL
THAT'S AVAILABLE TO THEM. AND
JUST ANOTHER SIDE NOTE, IF
SOMEBODY IS NOT AT A RESIDENCE
WHERE A MAIL BALLOT IS SENT TO,
IT DOES GET SENT BACK TO THE
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL AS
UNDELIVERABLE. AND THEY HAVE
PROCESSES ON HOW THEY DEAL WITH
THOSE UNDELIVERABLE BALLOTS. I
THINK THAT WHAT I HEARD SENATOR
ROSS SAY AND SENATOR CABALLERO
SAY, AND THEY'LL CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG, IS THAT WE SHOULD
JOIN OTHER STATES IN LEGISLATING
THAT THERE BE NOTICE THAT WE PUT
IT IN THE ACTUAL BILL. SO I'LL
LET YOU RESPOND TO THAT IN YOUR
CLOSE, ALL RIGHT, SENATOR
CABALLERO, ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
ALL RIGHT. SENATOR LAIRD, THEN,
SENATOR BARRASSO, I THINK YOU
GOT RIGHT UP TO MY QUESTION
BECAUSE, BASICALLY, I GET
EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN TALKED
ABOUT, BUT THIS IS ABOUT
INFORMATION BEING SHARED
OUTSIDE. AND THERE WAS A
CONSTANT REFRAIN ON HOW THE
INFORMATION IS BEING PROTECTED
IN CALIFORNIA. AND HOW DO YOU
EVEN KNOW TO JUST GIVE THE
INFORMATION TO SOMEBODY THAT'S
MOVED? I MEAN, IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE INFORMATION OUTSIDE THE
STATE, AND WE DO NOT HAVE THE
SAME GUARDRAILS THERE. TELL ME
WHY I SHOULDN'T BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT. TO BE CLEAR, WHEN
MEMBERS SEND DATA TO ERIC, IT IS
GOING OUTSIDE THE STATE, OF
COURSE, AND IT IS IN A SECURE
DATA CENTER HERE IN THE U.S.
THAT WE DON'T DISCLOSE PUBLICLY
FOR SECURITY REASONS. IT
UNDERGOES THOSE AUDITS I TALKED
ABOUT. SO THERE ARE MULTIPLE
LAYERS, AND I KNOW YOU'RE NOT
REALLY FOCUSED ON THAT, BUT THAT
DATA IS SECURE AT OUR DATA
CENTER. ANOTHER MEMBER STATE
ONLY RECEIVES INFORMATION ON A
CALIFORNIA VOTER. IF THAT VOTER
MOVES TO THAT STATE AND
REGISTERS TO VOTE OR OBTAINS A
DRIVER'S LICENSE, AND THE REASON
THEY'RE IDENTIFIED IS BECAUSE WE
COMPARE ALL STATES, ALL MEMBER
STATES, VOTER DATA AND DRIVER'S
LICENSE DATA AGAINST EACH OTHER.
AND THAT'S HOW WE IDENTIFIED
THAT, THAT VOTE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA VOTER HAS MOVED, SAY,
TO WASHINGTON STATE. AND THEN WE
CAN REPORT BACK TO THE TO THE
REGISTRAR IN CALIFORNIA THAT,
YOU KNOW, THAT THAT VOTER HAS
MOVED. THAT'S HOW THAT LET ME GO
BACK TO YOUR INITIAL STATEMENT.
YOU SAY IT'S SHARED WITH THE
DATABASE THAT'S GOT ALL THESE
SECURITY LEVELS, BUT OUTSIDE THE
STATE, YES. IT'S NOT IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I CAN'T DESCRIBE
THE NUMBER OF TIMES EVERYBODY
HAS ALL THESE SECURITY LEVELS.
AND WE READ ABOUT MASSIVE
BREACHES. HOW ARE WE SURE THAT
WE'RE PROTECTING THE PRIVACY OF
CALIFORNIA BY SHIPPING ALL THIS
DATA OUT OF STATE? A COUPLE OF
THINGS. ONE, OF COURSE, THERE IS
NO 100% GUARANTEE, RIGHT? WE ALL
KNOW THAT FROM THE DATA BREACHES
WE'VE SEEN AND HEARD ABOUT. BUT
THE DATA CENTER THAT WE ARE AT
INCLUDES BANKING DATA,
EDUCATIONAL DATA AND HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM DATA. AND THEY UNDERGO
INDUSTRY STANDARD AUDITS AND
PROTECTIONS. WE UNDERGO INDUSTRY
STANDARD AUDITS AND PROTECTIONS.
OUR MEMBERS KNOW WHERE THE DATA
IS AND THEY CAN PHYSICALLY GO TO
THE DATA CENTER AND DO THEIR OWN
INSPECTIONS OF THE DATA, PARDON
THE DATA IS HASHED, AND THE
SENSITIVE, MOST SENSITIVE DATA
ELEMENTS ARE HASHED. AND I WILL
ALSO SAY OUR DATA CENTER IS NOT
ACCESSIBLE BY THE INTERNET.
THERE IS NO WEB BASED
APPLICATION OR ACCESS TO THE
DATA ONLY TO ERIC EMPLOYEES HAVE
ACCESS TO IT THROUGH A SECURE
VPN NETWORK AND MEMBER STATES DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THE DATA
CENTER. LITERALLY TWO POINTS OF
ENTRY TO THE DATA CENTER. WELL,
THANK YOU, SENATOR. YES, I JUST
HOPE YOU'RE RIGHT. OKAY. THANK
YOU, SENATOR BARRASSO. I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY ANY OF THESE
ISSUES CAN'T BE DEALT WITH HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WITHIN OUR OWN
STATE GOVERNMENT. I MEAN, WE
ESPECIALLY WITH WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THE REST OF THE COUNTRY WITH
ALL THESE ACCUSATIONS OF
ELECTION IMPROPRIETIES, BECAUSE
SOME PEOPLE ARE UNHAPPY WITH THE
OUTCOME. I'VE ALWAYS BEEN REST
ASSURED THAT EACH STATE HAS
ABSOLUTE CONTROL OVER EVERYTHING
HAVING TO DO WITH THE ELECTION,
THE REGISTERING TO VOTE, THE UND
REGISTERING TO VOTE, THE
COUNTING, THE I MEAN, ALL OF
THAT IS IN OUR CONTROL, NOT
SOMEBODY ELSE'S. AND I THINK THE
MOMENT WE START GIVING OUT
INFORMATION TO OTHERS, WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT, WITH THE
PROTECTIONS THAT YOU HAVE BUILT
IN, IT REALLY MAKES IT LIKE IT'S
SETTING US UP FOR SOMETHING GOES
WRONG HERE AND OUR WHOLE SYSTEM
CAN BE QUESTIONED, ANYTHING THAT
COULD GO WRONG, EVEN IF IT'S
ONCE, THAT'S IT, WE LOSE THE
CREDIBILITY AND THERE'S ALREADY
ENOUGH ATTACKS ON OUR ELECTION
SYSTEM. EVEN IF THEY'RE LIES AND
WE DON'T NEED JUST ONE INCIDENT
OF SOMETHING GOING WRONG. SO
I'M. I'M VERY UNCOMFORTABLE. I
DON'T KNOW WHO ERIC IS. I DON'T
KNOW WHO. IS IT? ERIC OR ERICA?
IT'S THE SYSTEM. IT'S. YOU KNOW,
I'M JUST THE NAME OF THE
NONPROFIT ELECTRONIC
REGISTRATION INFORMATION CENTER.
WE HAVE OUR COMPUTERS NAMES.
YEAH. YOU GIVE NAMES SO YOU KNOW
WHO ERIC IS. WHAT ERIC DOES. I
MEAN, THESE ARE BIG QUESTIONS. I
THINK WE HAVE AN ENORMOUS
RESPONSIBILITY TO NOT, ALLOW
ANY. AND I HAVE ENORMOUS TRUST.
I'M NOT SAYING YOU'RE. YOU DON'T
HAVE TRUST. I HAVE ENORMOUS
TRUST IN OUR STATE SECRETARY OF
STATE AND OUR SYSTEM TO BE ABLE
TO DO WHATEVER WE NEED TO DO TO
CONTINUE TO BE SO AT THIS POINT,
I CAN'T SUPPORT. ALRIGHTY. THANK
YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SEEING NONE, IS THERE
A MOTION? SENATOR ROTH HAS MOVED
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
FURTHER INFORMATION, I DIRECT
YOU TO THE GREAT AMERICAN
COMMENTATOR GARY TRUDEAU AND
DOONESBURY FROM PAST SUNDAY.
THAT CARTOON ADDRESSED THIS VERY
SUBJECT MATTER, ALL RIGHT,
SENATOR ROTH HAS MOVED THE BILL.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PELLERIN? YES, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. AYE VOTE
AYE. MAINTAINING AN ACCURATE
VOTER FILE IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL TO GIVING VOTERS FAITH
IN OUR ELECTION SYSTEM. SO THIS
IS A VERY EXCELLENT TOOL THAT
HAS ALL THE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
IN PLACE TO ENSURE THAT WE DO
HAVE THOSE ACCURATE VOTER ROLLS.
AND IMAGINE, YOU KNOW, IF YOU
HAVE A LOVED ONE THAT GOES,
THAT'S, GROWING OLD AND ILL AND
THEY MOVE TO ANOTHER STATE TO
LIVE NEAR FAMILY AND THEY, THEY
DIE IN THAT OTHER STATE AND
THEY'RE STILL REGISTERED IN
CALIFORNIA. WE DON'T GET THAT
DATA SOMETIMES FOR A YEAR. SO
THIS WOULD BE ABLE WE'D BE ABLE
TO GET THAT DATA INSTANTANEOUSLY
AND BE ABLE TO UPDATE THOSE
RECORDS. SO IT DOES ADD MORE
TRUST AND INTEGRITY TO OUR
ELECTION SYSTEM. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MADAM SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL OR EXCUSE ME. MADAM
CHIEF COUNSEL, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. YES, THIS IS AB 2055, ITEM
16. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG Ã.
UMBERG. AYE. WILK. NÓ. WILK. NO.
ALLEN ASHBY. CABALLERO DURAZO
LAIRD. LAIRD AYE. NILO. NILO. NO
ROTH. ROTH. AYE. STERN WAHAB.
THAT'S 3 TO 2 WITH MEMBERS
MISSING. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL. ALL
RIGHT, AB FILE NUMBER 17, AB
2496. THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
SENATORS, FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB 2496. I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS UPFRONT THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES SURROUNDING THE
INTRODUCTION OF THIS
LEGISLATION. THE SITUATION IS
URGENT AND DIRE AS DESIGNATED BY
LAW. FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES PLAY
A CRITICAL ROLE IN THE CARE OF
SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN. I
INTRODUCED AB 2496 TO ENSURE
PFAS WOULD NOT LOSE THEIR
LIABILITY INSURANCE THIS YEAR,
LEADING TO DISPLACEMENT OF THE
9000 FOSTER CHILDREN IN THEIR
CARE. I WILL ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LISTED IN
THE ANALYSIS AND WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL
THEIR TIME ON THIS ISSUE. THE
BILL DOES TWO THINGS. IT ENSURES
THE RESPONSIBLE PARTIES ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ANY WRONGDOING
THAT HAPPENS TO THESE CHILDREN.
IT MAKES THE NECESSARY CHANGES
TO THE LAW ALLOWING THE PFAS
INSURER OF LAST RESORT, THE
NONPROFITS INSURANCE ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA, TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING INSURANCE AND ALLOWING
THESE CHILDREN TO REMAIN IN
THEIR CURRENT PLACEMENTS. WHAT
WE MUST KEEP IN MIND IS THAT OUR
NORTH STAR MUST BE PROTECTING
CHILDREN FROM ANY HARM. AS A
SOCIETY, THAT MUST BE THE
PRIORITY OF EVERY ONE OF US, AS
A SOCIETY THAT MUST BE THE
PRIORITY OF EVERY ONE OF US. WE
WANT TO PREVENT HARM FROM
HAPPENING IN THE FIRST PLACE. IF
HARM DOES TRAGICALLY HAPPEN TO
ANY OF THESE CHILDREN, THEN OUR
SECOND PRIORITY IS MAKING SURE
THE RESPONSIBLE PARTY IS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. AS WITH OTHER
INSURANCE MARKETS, ALMOST ALL
COMMERCIAL INSURERS HAVE LEFT OR
ARE LEAVING THE FFA MARKET.
NAYAK, A NAYAK, WHICH IS THE
NONPROFIT RISK POOL, NOW INSURES
90% OF PHAS IN CALIFORNIA. NAYAK
IS NO LONGER ABLE TO ACCEPT NEW
PHAS AND LATER THIS YEAR MUST
BEGIN NON RENEWALS FOR ALL
EXISTING PHAS UNLESS THERE IS A
CHANGE IN THE LAW ASSURING THE
PHAS WILL NOT BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR MATTERS OVER
WHICH THEY HAVE NO CONTROL. I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS DILIGENT WORK
IN SEEKING A SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM, AND I PLEDGE MY
COMMITMENT TO WORKING WITH ALL
PARTIES TO FIND A PATH THAT WILL
STAVE OFF THIS CATASTROPHIC,
ISSUE FACING THESE CHILDREN. I'M
PLEASED TO HAVE DAMIEN ZILIS
FROM THE NONPROFITS INSURANCE
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA AND CHRIS
STONER MERTZ FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES TO TESTIFY ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYWOMAN
PELLERIN. I'D LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR UMBERG AND THE REST OF
THE DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, AS WELL AS THEIR
STAFFS. IT WAS A PLEASURE TO
WORK WITH ALL OF THEM, I'M HERE
TO TALK ABOUT THE BILL THAT I AM
A SPONSOR FOR, WHICH IS AB. YOU
GIVE US YOUR NAME ALSO? YES.
THANK YOU, AB 2496, THE FOSTER
FAMILY ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. NÓ
YOUR NAME? OH, SORRY. MY NAME IS
DAMIEN ZILIS, AND I AM A
CORPORATE COUNSEL FOR NAIC, AND
I. I'M A FORMER LITIGATOR, SO I
HAVE SOME EXPERIENCE WITH SOME
WITH MOST OF THE MATTERS
INVOLVED IN THE BILL, AS
CORPORATE COUNSEL FOR NAIC AND A
FORMER LITIGATOR, I CAN
SINCERELY TELL YOU THAT AB 2496
IS NECESSARY, ALBEIT MODERATE.
BILL THAT LARGELY CODIFIES CASE
LAW AND ADHERES TO THE
FUNDAMENTAL TENET OF TORTS,
WHICH IS IF YOU BREAK IT, YOU
BUY IT, THE FOSTER FAMILY,
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES,
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS FAS, PLACED
FOSTER CHILDREN IN RESOURCE
HOMES. THE VAST MAJORITY DO SO
PROFESSIONALLY AND RESPONSIBLY
WITHOUT INCIDENT. HOWEVER, WHEN
THEY DO MAKE A MISTAKE AND THEY
INJURE A CHILD, THEY MUST BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
CORRESPONDINGLY HOLDING FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCIES LIABLE FOR THE
CONDUCT OF OTHERS IS RENDERING
THEM UNINSURABLE. CURRENTLY
APPROXIMATELY 90% OF PHAS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE INSURED BY MY
EMPLOYER. WE ARE THE DE FACTO
INSURER OF LAST RESORT. AS A
NONPROFIT OURSELVES, WE ARE A
NONPROFIT. WE ARE MISSION DRIVEN
TO SERVE NONPROFITS AND THEIR
STAKEHOLDERS. COMMERCIAL
INSURERS, ON THE OTHER HAND, DO
NOT HAVE SUCH A MANDATE, HAVE
ABANDONED THE MARKET. THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE 90% OF IT. THEY'VE LEFT
THE MARKET BECAUSE FHFA'S PLACED
FHFA'S FACE OPEN ENDED RISKS
WITHOUT PASSAGE OF AB 2496, NIAC
WILL HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO LEAVE
THE MARKET EFFECTIVE SEPTEMBER
30TH OF THIS YEAR, THROWING THE
SYSTEM AND MORE IMPORTANTLY, THE
VULNERABLE CHILDREN IN ITS CARE
INTO CRISIS. WE DO. WE DO NOT
WISH TO DO THAT, BUT CONTINUING
TO ENSURE FHFA'S WITHOUT AB
2496. THANK YOU. IF YOU COULD
WRAP IT UP, PLEASE. SURE. THAT
IT WOULD, WITHOUT THE PASSAGE OF
THIS. IT IS IT POSES AN
EXISTENTIAL RISK TO NICIE AND
THE 90% OF THE FAS THAT WE
INSURE. THANK YOU. CAN YOU URGE
AN I VOTE? YES, I DO, ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS, PLEASE.
YOUR CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M
CHRISTINE STONER MERTZ, CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES,
REPRESENTING OVER 165 NATIONALLY
ACCREDITED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS, MOST OF WHOM ARE
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES WORKING
WITH CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
INVOLVED IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. FAS ARE PRIVATE
NONPROFITS THAT ARE LICENSED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND UNDERGO RIGOROUS
LICENSURE PROCESSES. A NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION PROCESS, AND
ONGOING OVERSIGHT THROUGH THE
STATE AND COUNTY AGENCIES. THESE
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE FAMILY
BASED CARE WITH RELATIVES AND
OTHER FAMILIES OPENING THEIR
HOMES TO SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA, FAS PROVIDE 24 OVER
SEVEN SUPPORTS AND SERVICES TO
RESOURCE FAMILIES, INCLUDING
REUNIFICATION SUPPORT,
SUPERVISED SUPERVISION,
SUPERVISED VISITATION AND
ASSISTANCE WITH EVERYTHING FROM
TRANSPORTATION TO RESPITE CARE
FOR FAMILIES. THESE
ORGANIZATIONS ALSO PROVIDE CLOSE
TO 100% OF INTENSIVE SERVICES.
FOSTER CARE, A PROGRAM THAT
ADDRESSES THE MOST COMPLEX NEEDS
OF CHILDREN AND YOUTH. THESE
WRAPAROUND 24 OVER SEVEN
SERVICES PROVIDED THROUGH FAS
KEEP FOSTER CHILDREN AND FAMILY
BASED CARE, RATHER THAN IN
HIGHER LEVEL SERVICES. MANY
PROSPECTIVE RESOURCE FAMILIES
DECIDE TO BECOME APPROVED
FAMILIES WITH THESE NONPROFITS
BECAUSE THEY ARE COMMUNITY BASED
AND REFLECT THE COMMUNITIES THEY
SERVE. THEY'RE READILY AVAILABLE
TO ADDRESS INDIVIDUALIZED NEEDS
OF CHILDREN AND RESOURCE
FAMILIES, AND SPECIALIZE IN
SERVICES FOR MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CHILDREN, LGBTQ YOUTH, OLDER
FOSTER YOUTH, AND OTHERS WITH
UNIQUE NEEDS. THERE IS NOTHING
LIKE THEM IN THE STATE WITHOUT
FAS. RESOURCE FAMILIES WILL NOT
HAVE OPTIONS FOR WHAT
ORGANIZATION THEY WORK WITH AND
OPTIONS FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH
WILL BE SERIOUSLY LIMITED. AB
2496 IS NECESSARY FOR THE
SURVIVAL OF FAS IN CALIFORNIA.
IT PROVIDES AN ASSURANCE THAT IF
AN FFA HAS COMPLIED WITH ALL ITS
LEGAL MANDATES AND MEETS THE
STANDARDS EXPECTED OF THEM BY
THE STATE, THEY CANNOT BE HELD
LIABLE FOR SOMETHING OUT OF
THEIR CONTROL. THIS DOES NOT
DIMINISH THEIR LIABILITY FOR
THINGS THEY DO HAVE CONTROL
OVER. WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT AB
2495 AND ALL RIGHT. PERFECT. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
2496, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. MARK SUGDEN WITH THE
AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
JEFF. STATE ACRISURE INSURANCE
BROKERS OF CALIFORNIA, I'M HERE
REPRESENTING 200 INSURANCE
BROKERS WHO HAVE WRITTEN IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB 2496. THANK
YOU. I ESPERANTO TOGETHER WITH
SENECA FAMILY OF AGENCIES AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
HELLO. STEVE PARKHURST WITH
HEFFERNAN INSURANCE BROKERS,
NATIONAL NONPROFIT LEADER IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MARSHA LEWIS Ã KI¾M, CEO
OF ALTERNATIVE FAMILY SERVICES.
WE ARE AN FFA. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB 2496. THANK YOU. JOE
MARTINEZ, TRANSITIONS CHILDREN'S
SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. KIM LEWIS REPRESENTING
ASPIRANTE AND FFA, SERVING YOUTH
IN 35 DIFFERENT COUNTIES AND THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU, ASIA
BASIC WITH STANFORD SIERRA YOUTH
AND FAMILIES AND FFA HERE IN
SACRAMENTO STRONGLY STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I'M THOMAS
JOHNSON WITH PACIFIC CLINICS AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU
CARRIE ANN FARRELL HINES
REPRESENTING VISTA DEL MAR CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES. WE OPERATE
IN FFA IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF 2496. HELENA
LOPEZ, CEO OF A GREATER HOPE
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO REPRESENTING
ASSOCIATION OF FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. DAVID SMITH, HUMAN
RESOURCES DIRECTOR, QUINTANILLA
FAMILY SERVICES WE HAVE ABOUT 27
LOCATIONS STATEWIDE AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU. HELLO, JARED BORREGO, THE
DIRECTOR OF DEVELOPMENT FOR
KOINONIA FAMILY SERVICES. WE DO
RUN A STATEWIDE FFA
ORGANIZATION. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS. THANK YOU. OTHERS
IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE, LET'S
NOW TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 2496,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
OR THE TABLE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
ACTUALLY NOT IN OPPOSITION
ANYMORE, BUT, NANCY PEPPERONI
WITH THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ALSO TODAY FOR
THE CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
INSTITUTE, REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THAT WILL
BE AMENDED, THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
THE AUTHOR, AND TO THE COMMITTEE
, BUT AS AMENDED, WE'VE WE BOTH
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. JUSTIN GARRETT,
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES, ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA, WE HAD SUBMITTED
AN OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED LETTER
ON THE BILL AND PRINT. WE
UNDERSTAND THE DIRECTION AND THE
INTEREST AND THE AUTHOR ON
WORKING TOGETHER ON A SOLUTION.
APPRECIATE THAT OPENNESS AND
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
TOGETHER, MOVING FORWARD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. KELLY BROOKS, ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA, WE WOULD JUST ECHO
KSAT'S COMMENTS, LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH EVERYONE. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT, BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY THE BILL
. SENATOR WILKINS MOVED THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT. OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS? SEEING NONE. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TO PROTECT THESE 9000 FOSTER
KIDS FROM BEING DISPLACED. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, MADAM CHIEF
COUNSEL, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER 17, AB
2496 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN. THE MOTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS
NUMBER UMBERG I WILK WILK. I
ALLEN ASHBY CABALLERO. CABALLERO
I DURAZZO. LAIRD LAIRD I MILO.
MILO I. ROTH I. ROTH I STERNE.
WAHAB. YOU GOT 5 TO 0 MEMBERS
MISSING FIVE ZERO. ALL RIGHT,
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL. NEXT WE
HAVE FILE NUMBER 18. AND AFTER
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE FILE
NUMBER 19 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PAPIN. AND THEN AFTER THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER FILE ITEM.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPIN. AND
THEN I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PACHECO, WHO IS HERE, AND SHE
WILL BE NEXT AFTER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PAPIN. SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, CHAIR AND SENATORS,
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB 2839 THIS YEAR. CALIFORNIA IS
ENTERING ITS FIRST EVER
ELECTION, DURING WHICH
DISINFORMATION POWERED BY
GENERATIVE AI WILL POLLUTE OUR
INFORMATION ECOSYSTEMS LIKE
NEVER BEFORE. AND MILLIONS OF
VOTERS WILL NOT KNOW WHAT
IMAGES, AUDIO OR VIDEO THEY CAN
TRUST. SOME OF YOU HAVE PROBABLY
HEARD ABOUT A ROBOCALL THAT WAS
DISSEMINATED BACK IN JANUARY OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN, WHICH
ENCOURAGED VOTERS NOT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PRIMARY
ELECTION IN NEW HAMPSHIRE. THAT
AI GENERATED ROBOCALL WAS A
PRIME EXAMPLE OF A NEFARIOUS USE
OF GENERATIVE AI, WHICH SEEKS TO
DISRUPT OUR ELECTIONS. THIS TYPE
OF ELECTION DISRUPTION IS NOT
NEW, BUT THE MEANS OF
DISSEMINATING DISINFORMATION
ABOUT AN ELECTION IS MUCH MORE
SOPHISTICATED DUE TO THE ACCESS
TO VERY SOPHISTICATED GENERATIVE
AI PLATFORMS. IMAGINE ANOTHER
EXAMPLE IN WHICH A DEEPFAKE TV
AD DEPICTS AN ELECTION OFFICIAL
SAYING THAT THEY RIGGED THE
VOTES IN FAVOR OF ONE CANDIDATE,
OR A MAILER SHOWING FALSE IMAGES
OF TAMPERED BALLOTS. TODAY, IT
CAN BE DIFFICULT FOR THE AVERAGE
PERSON TO KNOW WHAT IMAGES
BEFORE THEM ARE REAL OR
FABRICATED. THIS TYPE OF
ELECTION RELATED DISINFORMATION
CAN DRAMATICALLY AFFECT VOTER
BEHAVIOR AND UNDERMINE FAITH IN
OUR ELECTIONS, EVEN IF THEY ARE
LATER DEBUNKED. AB 2839
ADDRESSES THIS GROWING THREAT BY
PROHIBITING BAD ACTORS FROM
DISTRIBUTING DIGITALLY ALTERED
MAILERS, ROBOCALLS, AND VIDEO
ADVERTISEMENTS THAT ARE
INTENTIONALLY DECEPTIVE TO
VOTERS AND DEPICT FALSE
INFORMATION PERTAINING TO A
CANDIDATE RUNNING FOR OFFICE, AN
OFFICER CONDUCTING AN ELECTION,
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL, OR VOTING
EQUIPMENT. THESE CRITERIA WERE
CAREFULLY CRAFTED USING THE
INPUT OF STRONG DEFENDERS OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TODAY IS
LAURA GERSHENSON, REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE FOR
TECHNOLOGY AND DEMOCRACY. THANK
YOU. FLOOR IS YOURS. OH, LET ME
ASK IF YOU ACCEPTED THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. YES ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
I'M LAURA GERSHENSON WITH CITED
THE CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE FOR
TECHNOLOGY AND DEMOCRACY, A
PROJECT OF CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE. AB 2839 SEEKS TO PROTECT
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS
FROM THE WORST OF THE WORST DEEP
FAKES MEANT TO DEFRAUD OUR
ELECTORATE AND UNDERMINE OUR
FAITH IN DEMOCRACY. IMAGINE TWO
HIT PIECES. ONE SHOWS A SMOKY
ROOM AND SAYS THAT YOU'RE FOR
SALE. NOT A GOOD THING, BUT IT'S
. BUT IT'S NOT THE SAME AS THE
OTHER ONE, WHICH IS AN ACTUAL
DEEPFAKE OF YOU AND YOU ARE
CAUGHT ON TAPE TAKING A BRIBE.
AGAIN, YOU MAY NOT LIKE THE
FIRST ONE, BUT THE SECOND ONE IS
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT. IT'S
INTENDED TO DEFAME YOU. IT'S
INTENDED TO DEFRAUD THE VOTERS,
AND IT'S INTENDED TO. AND ONCE
IT IS SEEN, IT CAN'T BE UNSEEN.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF THERE'S A
LITTLE LABEL AT THE BOTTOM OF IT
THAT SAYS AI GENERATED, IT'S
JUST SUCH A STRONG IMAGE THAT IT
WILL CHANGE HOW PEOPLE FEEL
ABOUT THE ELECTION AND HOW THEY
VOTE. THIS BILL SEEKS TO STOP
THAT DEEPFAKE AND OTHER
SIMILARLY HARMFUL DEEPFAKES. BUT
IN A VERY NARROW FASHION. IT
ONLY APPLIES TO CANDIDATES.
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND VOTING APPARATUS.
IT IS NARROWLY DRAFTED TO BE
TIME LIMITED, ONLY APPLY TO THE
WORST OF THE WORST DEEPFAKES
THAT ARE DIGITALLY MANIPULATED
AND MATERIALLY DECEPTIVE, AND
ARE DONE WITH MALICE AND WITH
AND WITH CONTENT THAT A
REASONABLE PERSON PERSON WOULD
THINK IS AUTHENTIC AND ARE
REASONABLY LIKELY TO HARM THE
ELECTION OR A CANDIDATE, OR TO
CHANGE THE OUTCOME. THESE NARROW
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL ARE DONE
TO ENSURE THAT WE COMPLY WITH
THE FIRST AMENDMENT. AND TO
PROTECT OUR OUR ELECTIONS AND
OUR INTEGRITY. CONGRESS HASN'T
ACTED TO PROTECT OUR ELECTIONS.
AND WITH SO MUCH AT STAKE IN THE
2024 ELECTION, IF THEY DON'T DO
IT THIS YEAR, THEY'RE CLEARLY
NOT GOING TO DO IT. IT'S UP TO
CALIFORNIA TO ALL OF YOU TO
PROTECT OUR ELECTIONS AND TO
PROTECT OUR DEMOCRACY. WE ASK
FOR YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF, AB 2839,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
HI, DYLAN HOFFMAN, ON BEHALF OF
TECHNET IN A SUPPORTIVE, AMENDED
POSITION. ON BEHALF OF CAL
CHAMBER, ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
AMENDED POSITION. THANK YOU,
CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS BRIAN MIRAMONTEZ WITH
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JOHN KOEPKE.
ON BEHALF OF THE COMPUTER AND
COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
AMENDED POSITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, PETER KELLY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS
ASSOCIATION, SUPPORTING THE BILL
AS OF AMENDED ON THE 24TH. THANK
YOU. VANESSA ATLAS, ON BEHALF OF
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG, REPRESENTING 80
INDIVISIBLES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 2839, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. GOING
ONCE, GOING TWICE. OH HERE WE GO
. OKAY JUST BRIEFLY DANNY
KENDALL KAISER, ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION,
RESPECTFULLY STILL IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. JACKIE,
ON BEHALF OF DISH AND DIRECT TV,
WE HAVEN'T OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. WE'RE HOPEFUL
TO WORK WITH STAFF TO RESOLVE
OUR OUTSTANDING CONCERNS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
STEPHANIE SHROUD, ON BEHALF OF
THE MOTION PICTURE ASSOCIATION.
IN A RESPECTFUL OPPOSE. UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION, APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR FOR
WORKING WITH US TO MAKE SOME
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS TO EXEMPT
STREAMING SERVICES. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSIONS INTO
THE SUMMER AND HOPEFULLY AS OF
RIGHT NOW, WE'RE STILL IN
OPPOSITION. BUT HOPEFULLY WE
HOPE TO RESOLVE THAT THROUGH THE
SUMMER AND REMOVE THAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON. GRACE COPELAND
ON BEHALF OF WARNER BROTHERS
DISCOVERY, WE ARE ALIGNED WITH
NPA'S POSITION AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THE DISCUSSIONS.
THANK YOU, TIFFANY FAN, ON
BEHALF OF SONY PICTURES ONLINE
OUR COMMENTS WITH THE MOTION
PICTURE ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, PAT
JOYCE ON BEHALF OF NBC
UNIVERSAL, ALSO ECHO THE NPA'S
COMMENTS. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION, SEEING NO
ONE ELSE APPROACHED THE
MICROPHONE. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, NO QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT.
IS THERE A MOTION SO MOVED.
SENATOR ROTH HAS MOVED THE BILL.
SOME MEMBER PELLERIN, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU.
SENATORS GETTING THE RIGHT
INFORMATION TO VOTERS IS CRUCIAL
TO A FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACY, AND
IT BECOMES VERY DIFFICULT TO
ENSURE THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTION WHEN CONVINCING
DEEPFAKES ARE SPREAD ONLINE, BY
PHONE OR THROUGH THE MAIL TO
INTENTIONALLY MISINFORM THE
PUBLIC, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT, MADAM COUNCIL,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM 18 AB 2839. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. UMBERG
A UMBERG I WILK ALLEN ASHBY
CABALLERO. DURAZZO LAIRD. LAIRD
I NILO. NILO. NO ROTH. ROTH I
STERN. WAHAB. THAT'S 3 TO 1 SO
FAR WITH MEMBERS MISSING 3 TO 1.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PAPIN. THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PACHECO. HAPPENING THEN. PACHECO
. YOU READY? OKAY, GREAT. I'LL
HAVE MY WITNESSES COME FORWARD
ON AB 2037. LARA IS YOURS. GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SEIBERLING, I DID NOT. WITH HIS
WITNESS.
SIMILAR TO YOURS. THANK YOU. I
SAID I'M WAITING FOR MY
WITNESSES TO COME IN. I SEE THEM
ENTERING THE ROOM. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I KNOW IT'S BEEN
A LONG MORNING AND YOU GOT A
LONG WAY TO GO. OKAY. DO YOU
HAVE YOUR OTHER WITNESS? I'LL
START. AND THEN AS THIS PERSON
COMES IN, IT'LL BE FINE. OKAY.
SO THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, AB 2037 WILL GIVE
COUNTY SELLERS THE AUTHORITY TO
TEST AND VERIFY PUBLICLY OWNED
EV CHARGERS. COUNTY SELLERS ARE
TASKED WITH TESTING AND
VERIFYING COMMERCIAL MEASUREMENT
DEVICES, SUCH AS GROCERY STORE
SCALES, GAS PUMPS. THEIR JOB IS
TO MAKE SURE YOU GET WHAT YOU
PAY FOR. GENERALLY, THEIR
JURISDICTION COVERS PRIVATELY
OWNED EQUIPMENT. AS SUCH, THERE
IS CURRENTLY NO ENTITY IN CHARGE
OF PUBLICLY OWNED EV CHARGERS.
TO ENSURE CONFIDENCE,
IMPARTIALITY, AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION, IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
COUNTY SELLERS HAVE CLEAR
AUTHORITY TO TEST AND VERIFY
PUBLICLY OWNED EV CHARGERS. I
RECENTLY AMENDED THE BILL TO
CONDITIONALLY EXEMPT PUBLICLY
OWNED ELECTRICAL UTILITIES
CHARGERS IF THEY WANT TO
EXERCISE THIS EXEMPTION, THEY
MUST TEST THEIR CHARGERS TO THE
SAME ACCURACY STANDARDS AS THE
SELLERS AND TEST THEM EVERY SIX
MONTHS. THIS IS A HIGHER TESTER
TESTING FREQUENCY THAN THE
COUNTY DOES, AND THAT IS FOR
GOOD REASON. THE PWS, WHICH ARE
THE PUBLICLY OPERATED UTILITIES,
ARE NOT AN INDEPENDENT THIRD
PARTY. AND IF WE'RE GOING TO
ALLOW FOR SELF VERIFICATION,
THEN ROBUST GUARDRAILS MUST BE
IN PLACE. THE PWS HAVE TESTIFIED
THAT THEY ALREADY CONDUCT THIS
TESTING ON A MONTHLY BASIS. SO I
BELIEVE THIS AMENDMENT, HAVING
THEM PROVIDE RESULTS EVERY SIX
MONTHS IS A REASONABLE AND
BALANCED APPROACH WITH INFLATION
AND GROWING INCOME DISPARITY,
PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING HARD
TIMES WHEN EVERY DOLLAR COUNTS,
IT'S CRITICAL THAT YOU GET WHAT
YOU PAY FOR, HERE TO TESTIFY
WITH ME TODAY IS MATT SAVOLINE
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY SEALERS,
AND MR. JOHN HUNTZINGER, WHO
WILL GO AFTER MATT, WHO IS A
SEALER HIMSELF, OR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO GO FIRST, MR.
HUNTZINGER? SURE. OKAY PLEASE.
YEAH. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS JOSH
HUNTZINGER. I'M THE PLACER
COUNTY SEALER OF WEIGHTS AND
MEASURES, ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS AND SEALERS
ASSOCIATION. AS WAS MENTIONED,
THE COUNTY SEALERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE TESTING AND
VERIFYING THE ACCURACY OF ALL
COMMERCIAL WEIGHING AND
MEASURING DEVICES IN CALIFORNIA,
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS REPRESENT A NEW AND
EMERGING TECHNOLOGY, WHICH IS
BECOMING MORE AND MORE
PREVALENT, THROUGHOUT OUR
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK. UNLIKE
VIRTUALLY ALL OTHER TYPES OF
WEIGHING AND MEASURING DEVICES,
MANY ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS ARE OPERATED ON CITY OR
COUNTY PROPERTY WITH A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT BUSINESS MODELS
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM. THIS BILL
SEEKS TO CREATE AN EQUITABLE
MARKETPLACE FOR CONSUMERS AND
FOR INDUSTRY, SO THAT BOTH THE
CONSUMERS AND THE INDUSTRY ARE
OPERATING FROM THE SAME POSITION
, WHETHER ON PUBLIC PROPERTY OR
ON PRIVATE PROPERTY AND SO THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE THAT ONE SET OF
STANDARDS IS APPLIED TO ALL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE,
REGARDLESS OF WHAT WHOSE
PROPERTY THEY ARE LOCATED ON.
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MATTHEW SEIBERLING, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS AND SEALERS
ASSOCIATION. I'LL BE BRIEF. I
KNOW YOU HAVE A LONG DAY TODAY,
THE FUNDAMENTAL AND MOST BASIC
PURPOSE FOR THIS BILL IS IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE BUYING
SOMETHING THAT'S BEING MEASURED
AND THERE'S A DEVICE THAT'S
DETERMINING THE COST BASED ON
THAT MEASURE, THE COUNTY SEAL IS
CURRENTLY TEST IT, SEAL IT, AND
HAVE JURISDICTION OVER IT, WE
VIEW THIS DEVICE AS NO
DIFFERENT, WE DON'T THINK
THERE'S A DISTINCTION WHETHER OR
NOT, IT'S OWNED BY A PUBLIC
ENTITY OR A PRIVATE ENTITY. IF
THERE'S A COMMERCIAL DEVICE IN
THE MIX, THE COUNTY SEALER,
THROUGH THEIR THEIR LICENSING
WITH THE STATE HAS JURISDICTION
OVER IT AND NEEDS TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE THAT CONSUMER
PROTECTION, WE DO AS THE AUTHOR
HAS POINTED OUT, HAVE OFFERED A
CONDITIONAL EXEMPTION, WHICH IS
THE FIRST IN OUR EXTREMELY LONG
LIST OF DEVICES THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE JURISDICTION
OVER, IN THE MEANTIME, DURING
THE INTERIM PERIOD HERE, WE'D
LIKE TO HAVE A CHANCE TO AT
LEAST CHECK IN WITH THE DEVICE,
CONSIDERING THAT WE'RE TAKING
OUR JURISDICTION COMPLETELY OFF
OF IT. WE'RE NOT CHARGING FEES,
WE'RE NOT TESTING, WE'RE
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO TEST THEIR
OWN DEVICES AND VERIFY THE
ACCURACY OF THEM. WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO CHECK IN WITH THEM AT
LEAST TWICE A YEAR, JUST TO MAKE
SURE THE TESTING IS BEING DONE,
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DEVICES WORK AND FOR THOSE
REASONS, WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT AB 2037 15 WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE PLACER COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, KELLY BROOKS, ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
LET'S TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 2037,
PLEASE APPROACH THE EITHER THE
TABLE OR THE MICROPHONE. MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, GREG COOK
REPRESENTING NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
POWER AGENCY. WE'RE A JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY CONSISTING OF
16 LOCAL LOCALLY OWNED
GOVERNMENT STATE, CITY, LOCAL
DISTRICT THAT OPERATE THEIR OWN
ELECTRICITY SERVICE. WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE RELIABILITY
OF OUR SERVICE FROM THE
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM, FROM THE
ELECTRONS THAT WE PROVIDE AND
FOR THE BILLING OF THOSE
SYSTEMS. WE DID SEEK AN
EXEMPTION FROM THIS REQUIREMENT
FROM THE AUTHOR AND FOR NUMEROUS
MEETINGS, SHE HAS AGREED TO
ACCEPT THE CONDITIONS THAT WE'VE
OFFERED, WHICH PROVIDE FOR
GREATER RELIABILITY ON THE PART
OF THE UTILITY, PROVIDE FOR
RECORD KEEPING TO PROVIDE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE RECORDS ARE
UP TO DATE AND MAKE PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THOSE RECORDS
AVAILABLE. WE WILL FOLLOW EVERY
REQUIREMENT THAT CURRENT
CALIFORNIA REGULATION AND
FEDERAL REGULATION REQUIRES
REGARDING TESTING. WE DO HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL IN ITS
PRESENT FORM. WE DID SUGGEST TO
THE AUTHOR THAT BECAUSE SHE
SAID, WE THINK IF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO BE
RESPONSIBLE, THEN THEY SHOULD
HAVE AN EXTRA HURDLE. WE'VE SAID
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO THIS, BUT
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS AS OPPOSED TO
THE BIANNUAL BASIS THAT THE
SEALERS REQUIRE, SHE SAID. NO, I
DON'T TRUST ANY COUNSEL SAYING,
WELL, I'M JUST GOING TO CUT MY
BUDGET, SO WE'RE GOING TO REDUCE
THE OPERATION AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO IT. ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS. SO I'M GOING TO PUT SIX
MONTHS IN THERE BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THAT PROVIDES GREATER
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE PART OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. WE ABSOLUTELY
DISAGREE WITH THAT. WE ARE FULLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SERVICE THAT
WE PROVIDE OUR CUSTOMERS. I
STRONGLY URGE A NO VOTE ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. ANTHONY
SAMPSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY, SCOPA MEMBERS ARE
PUBLICLY OWNED ELECTRIC
UTILITIES THAT ARE GOVERNED BY
LOCAL OFFICIALS WHO LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE.
PLUS ARE NOT FOR PROFIT PUBLIC
AGENCIES WITH THE PRIMARY DUTY
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS, WHICH IS
WHY THEY CONSISTENTLY OUTPERFORM
THE PRIVATE SECTOR IN
RELIABILITY, AFFORDABILITY AND
CUSTOMER SATISFACTION. LET ME
START BY CLARIFYING WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT AND WHAT IT IS NOT
ABOUT. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
ENSURING EV CHARGERS ARE NOT
INCORRECTLY ASSESSING COSTS ON
CONSUMERS. THIS BILL IS NOT
ABOUT FIXING CHARGERS THAT ARE
BROKEN OR OUT OF ORDER, WHICH IS
A BROADER ISSUE BEING DISCUSSED
AND ADDRESSED SEPARATELY IN
DIFFERENT LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS.
ON THAT ISSUE. POLLS HAVE A HIGH
RELIABILITY RECORD ON THIS ISSUE
AND HAVE PROCESSES IN PLACE TO
FIX BROKEN CHARGERS IN A TIMELY
FASHION. WITH THIS DISTINCTION
IN MIND, THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
TO AB 2037 ALLOWS POLICE TO
CONDUCT THEIR OWN INSPECTIONS
INSTEAD OF PAYING THE COUNTY
STEELERS TO DO THEM. WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THOSE
AMENDMENTS. HOWEVER, THE
AMENDMENTS ARBITRARILY REQUIRE
POLICE TO INSPECT CHARGERS EVERY
SIX MONTHS, WHICH IS FOUR TIMES
AS FREQUENT AS THE COUNTY
STEELERS TO BE CLEAR, SCAPA IS
PREPARED TO REMOVE OPPOSITION
WITH THE REQUIREMENT THAT PWS
INSPECT ANNUALLY AT A MINIMUM AS
SOON AS THIS BILL TAKES EFFECT.
THIS WOULD RESULT IN INSPECTIONS
AT TWICE THE RATE AS REQUIRED OF
THE COUNTY STEELERS, AND
INSPECTIONS WOULD BEGIN MORE
THAN A DECADE BEFORE THE
STEELERS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
INSPECT, BUT REQUIRING
INSPECTIONS EVERY SIX MONTHS
WOULD QUADRUPLE INSPECTION
COSTS, WHICH WOULD BE BORNE BY
PWS AND THEIR RATEPAYERS.
MOREOVER, AS PWS INSTALL MORE
AND MORE CHARGERS, THEY WILL
NEED FLEXIBILITY TO ENSURE THEY
CAN INSPECT ALL OF THEM AT A
REASONABLE FREQUENCY. THAT
DOESN'T CREATE UNREASONABLE COST
TO CONSUMERS. AN ANNUAL
FREQUENCY REQUIREMENT WOULD
PROVIDE THAT FLEXIBILITY, AND
FOR THESE REASONS, WE MUST
OPPOSE AB 30 2037 UNLESS IT'S
AMENDED. THANK YOU ALREADY.
THANK YOU. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
TO AB 2037. GOOD MORNING, KIARA
ROSS. ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BURBANK, BURBANK WATER AND
POWER, I'M OPPOSITION UNLESS
AMENDED WITH THE SIX MONTHS TO
ONE YEAR ANNUAL INSPECTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MICROBES.
TODAY, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION, SHARED THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS AND OPPOSITION PARTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION? AB 2037 SEEING NO
ONE. LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. SENATOR ROTH. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. YOU KNOW, WE HAD
ANOTHER BILL IN ANOTHER CONTEXT,
AND I DON'T REMEMBER WHERE
HAVING TO DO WITH COUNTY SEWERS.
AND I THINK THEY WERE CALLED
REGISTERED SERVICE AGENTS OR
RSAS. AND MY RECOLLECTION OF THE
BILL IS WE HAVE THESE RSAS WHO
ARE CERTIFIED SEALERS WHO
CONTRACT, AND ARE PAID TO GO OUT
AND INSPECT REPAIR SERVICE.
THESE ELECTRIC CHARGERS. AND
WHEN THEY DO, I GUESS THE
QUESTION WAS THEY ALSO HAVE TO
CERTIFY THAT THE ELECTRICITY,
THE METER, WHATEVER IT IS, IT'S
CALLED SOMETHING ELSE, IS
ACCURATE. AND THE QUESTION WAS,
DO THEY HAVE TO DO THAT WHEN
THEY'RE NOT REPAIRING THE, THE
PIECE OF THE CHARGER THAT
DELIVERS THE ELECTRICITY TO THE
VEHICLE? AND I THINK THAT WAS
THE SUBJECT OF THE BILL. BUT THE
POINT IS YOU IF YOU'RE A
MUNICIPAL UTILITY, I ASSUME YOU
GO OUT AND YOU INSPECT AND
REPAIR CHARGERS THAT HAVE
ISSUES. AND AT THAT POINT IN
TIME, IF YOU ARE CERTIFYING THE
ACCURACY OF THE METER, DO YOU DO
THAT? YES. OKAY. INSPECTING AND
REPAIRING IS ONE ISSUE. AND
OBVIOUSLY WE DISCUSSED IN OTHER
CONTEXT THIS IS ABOUT I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS NØ I READ
THE BILL, I MY QUESTION IS WHEN
YOU'RE INSPECTING AND REPAIRING
THE ELECTRIC CHARGING DEVICE, DO
YOU ALSO CHECK TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE POWER THAT'S BEING DELIVERED
TO THE VEHICLE AND CHARGE TO THE
CUSTOMER IS ACCURATELY CHARGED?
YES. IT'S ENSURING THAT THE COST
TO THE CONSUMER IS. AND YES,
THEY ARE ALSO BENEFITING FROM
THE I FIGURED AS MUCH. AND IF
YOU WERE GOING TO SAY NO, I WAS
GOING TO SAY WHY NOT? AND SO MY
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR IS, DO
THESE ADDITIONAL ACTIVITIES THAT
OCCURRED DURING THE YEAR OUTSIDE
OF A NORMAL INSPECTION, COUNT
TOWARD YOUR EVERY SIX MONTH
INSPECTION? WELL, WHAT THEY
TESTIFIED TO IN THE LAST
COMMITTEE, NO, I UNDERSTAND I
UNDERSTAND, BUT I MEAN, MY
QUESTION IS, WELL, THEY'RE DOING
IT EVERY MONTH. EVERY MONTH.
THEY TELL US THEY GO OUT AND
THEY INSPECT EVERY SINGLE MONTH
FOR ACCURACY. BUT I'M BUT MY
QUESTION IS, MY QUESTION IS
THIS. IF YOU THEY HAVE A SIX
MONTH SCHEDULE FOR 100 ELECTRIC
CHARGERS. BUT IF DURING THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR THEY ARE
EITHER REQUIRED OR THEY GO OUT
AND THEY REPAIR AND FIX THE
CHARGER AND THEN CERTIFY AT THAT
POINT THAT THE CHARGERS
DELIVERING THE ELECTRICITY THAT
THEY'RE CHARGING THE CUSTOMER
FOR, DOES THAT COUNT TOWARD THE
SIX MONTH INSPECTION, EVEN
THOUGH IT'S NOT ON THE SCHEDULE?
THAT'S THE MECHANICS OF HOW IT
WILL WORK. SENATOR, I DON'T
REALLY KNOW. I THINK THAT THEY
SHOULD BE. EVERY SIX MONTHS,
WE'LL GET THEM ON A REGULAR
SCHEDULE AND WE'LL HAVE
REPORTING ON A REGULAR SCHEDULE.
IF THEY WERE THERE IN FEBRUARY
AND THE REPORTING IS IN JUNE,
THEY CAN CERTAINLY TELL US IN
FEBRUARY. IT WORKED. YOU KNOW, I
DON'T KNOW, BUT I BELIEVE THEY
SHOULD BE ON A REGULAR SCHEDULE.
AND AGAIN, THIS IS BASED UPON
THEIR OWN EFFORTS. SO TO COME TO
THIS COMMITTEE AND TESTIFY, OH
MY GOSH, THIS WOULD COST OUR
RATEPAYERS MORE. WHEN THERE WAS
A VERY EMPHATIC TESTIMONY IN THE
LAST COMMITTEE THAT WE ARE OUT
THERE EVERY MONTH TESTING FOR
ACCURACY SIX MONTHS. I
UNDERSTAND REPORTING, I
UNDERSTAND THAT I UNDERSTAND THE
NATURE OF THE DISPUTES YOU'RE
HAVING WITH THE MUNICIPALLY
OWNED UTILITIES. I'M THERE EVERY
MONTH. THEN WHY NOT DO IT? TELL
US WHAT HAPPENS IN JUNE. SO AS
LONG AS THEY FIGURE OUT WHETHER
IT'S A SERVICE REPAIR AND
CERTIFICATION OR A SEPARATE
CERTIFICATION TRIP, WHICH THE
SEALERS WOULD DO, IT ALL COUNTS
TOWARD AN INSPECTION. THE
CERTIFICATION IS THE IS THE
ISSUE, NOT WHETHER IT'S
CURRENTLY BEING MAINTAINED ON
THEM, WHETHER IT'S A SERVICE
VISIT, SERVICE REPAIR, AND
CERTIFICATION, OR A SEPARATELY
SCHEDULED CERTIFICATION. IT ALL
COUNTS FOR AN INSPECTION EVERY
SIX MONTHS. I THINK THE
CERTIFICATION IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING OF THOSE, SO I'D
LIKE TO SEE CERTIFICATION EVERY
SIX MONTHS IF THEY HAVE TO MAKE
A SEPARATE TRIP. I DON'T BELIEVE
THEY DO BECAUSE THEY'VE TOLD ME
THEY'RE DOING IT EVERY MONTH. SO
WHY ARE WE TALKING ABOUT A
SEPARATE TRIP? I THINK WE'RE
SAYING THE SAME THING, BUT I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE OKAY, BECAUSE YOU CAN SEE I
HAVE A SIX MONTH SCHEDULE FOR
INSPECTION. BUT IN BETWEEN THE
INSPECTIONS, I SEND A CREW OUT
THERE AND THEY SERVICE REPAIR,
AND THEN THEY CERTIFY THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO MAKE ANOTHER
TRIP JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE TWO
WEEKS INSIDE OF THE SIX MONTHS
THAT SHOULD COUNT. SO I WOULD
EXPECT THAT THAT'S THE WAY THIS
IS GOING TO WORK. IF IT DOESN'T,
I GUESS SOMEBODY OTHER THAN ME,
BECAUSE I WON'T BE HERE, WILL BE
BACK HERE NEXT YEAR FIXING IT. I
AM GOING TO VOTE FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU SIR, I PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T SAY ANYTHING. THEN IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE GOING TO VOTE
FOR THE BILL. BUT TO YOUR
QUESTION THAT THE CATEGORICAL
CATEGORICAL CRITERIA WE'RE
LOOKING FOR CAN BE GATHERED
DURING THESE THESE REGULAR, YOU
KNOW, MAINTENANCE INSPECTIONS, I
THINK WHAT THE COUNTY STEELERS
ARE LOOKING FOR, JUST TO BE
COMPLETELY CLEAR AND BELIEVE IT
OR NOT, IS JUST SOME SORT OF
AVENUE TO CHECK IN AND MAKE SURE
THAT THESE ARE WORKING
CORRECTLY. BECAUSE OUR, OUR
PRIMARY GOAL AND ROLE IN THE
PROCESS IS CONSUMER PROTECTION.
SO IF WE'RE TAKING OUR HANDS
OFF, WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE CAN CHECK IN AND MAKE SURE
SOMEONE, SOMEWHERE IS TESTING
THESE FOR THE CRITERIA THAT
WE'RE CURRENTLY LOOKING FOR. AND
I'M SURE OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
GOING TO APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT IF THEY DRIVE AN ELECTRIC
VEHICLE, ONE WHEN THEY SHOW UP
AT A CHARGER, AT WORKS, AND TWO
WHEN THEY PUT THE ELECTRICITY IN
IT, THE VOLTS, THEY'RE GOING TO
BE CHARGED FOR WHAT THEY WHAT
THEY ACTUALLY GET. SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, HAS
THERE BEEN A MOTION? SO MOVED.
SENATOR ROTH HAS MOVED THE BILL.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I'LL
JUST REQUEST WE REQUEST? HOW
ABOUT RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN I
VOTE? THANK YOU SIR, AS LONG AS
IT'S RESPECTFULLY. THEN WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL. ALL
RIGHT. GOOD. SO. ALL RIGHT,
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
19, AB 2037. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS,
BERG I NUMBER I WILK ALLEN ASHBY
CABALLERO. DURAZZO. LAIRD. LAIRD
I NEELO I NEIL I ROTH. ROTH I
STERNE O'HARA. 4 TO 0 FOUR ZERO.
GOING TO PUT THAT ON CALL ALL
RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPPIN
YOUR NEXT BILL. FILE NUMBER 20.
IF ANYONE'S IN THE HALLWAY ON
FILE NUMBER 20, THEY SHOULD COME
INTO THE COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM,
IF THEY WISH TO VOICE THEIR VIEW
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. SO. AB
2515, WE'VE HAD A ROBUST
DISCUSSION ON THIS, ON THIS
BILL, AND THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS. I DON'T THINK THAT
THEY'RE IN THE ANALYSIS AND SO
WE'LL NEED TO GO OVER THEM. YOU
WANT TO START OR YOU WANT ME TO
START? GO AHEAD. START WITH THE.
WHY DON'T WHY DON'T WE START
WITH YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPIN,
AND THEN YOU'LL I'LL CONFIRM.
OKAY. THANK YOU. I HAVEN'T
THEY'RE NOT A PART OF MY
REMARKS, BUT I THINK I'VE GOT A
PRETTY GOOD IDEA WHAT THEY ARE,
AND THEY ARE ACCEPTABLE, JUST SO
YOU KNOW. SO, FIRST OF ALL, I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR ROBUST
ENGAGEMENT, THIS BILL IS ABOUT
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT,
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ENSURING
WOMEN'S HEALTH EQUITY. AB 2515
THE TAMPON ACT, WHICH STANDS FOR
TAKE ALL MENSTRUAL PRODUCT PFAS,
OUT NOW. WE'LL SET A THRESHOLD
OF TEN PARTS PER MILLION FOR
UNINTENTIONALLY ADDED PFAS IN
2027. IN PRACTICE, THIS MEANS
MANUFACTURERS WILL HAVE TWO
YEARS TO IDENTIFY ANY
UNINTENTIONALLY ADDED PFAS IN
THEIR SUPPLY CHAIN, SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE A
LONG TIME AGO. WE'VE BEEN WE
HAVE SEEN MULTIPLE BILLS COME
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE RECENTLY
THAT ADDRESS PFAS IN VARIOUS
PRODUCTS, AND FOR GOOD REASON.
THESE FOREVER CHEMICALS ARE
UBIQUITOUS AND CAUSE SEVERE
HEALTH PROBLEMS, INCLUDING
HORMONE AND IMMUNE SYSTEM
DISRUPTION, KIDNEY AND LIVER
DAMAGE, AND, OF COURSE, CANCER.
HOWEVER, I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS ARE DIFFERENT
AND REQUIRE A HIGHER LEVEL OF
SCRUTINY. THESE PRODUCTS ARE
USED IN THE MOST INTIMATE WAY
POSSIBLE IN AN AREA OF THE BODY
THAT IS DELICATE AND HIGHLY
VASCULAR. ADDITIONALLY, WOMEN'S
HEALTH IS UNEQUALLY COMPROMISED
AS ANY HUMAN THAT HAS A UTERUS
MUST USE THESE PRODUCTS FOR 3 TO
7 DAYS OUT OF EVERY MONTH FOR
ROUGHLY 40 YEARS OF THEIR LIFE.
IMAGINE THE DAMAGE THAT CAN BE
DONE FROM SUCH AN INTIMATE USE
OVER REPEATED EXPOSURE. AB 25
1515 IS A REINTRODUCTION OF A
SIMILAR BILL. I CARRIED LAST
YEAR, AB 246, WHICH MADE IT TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK BUT WAS
VETOED. IN THE GOVERNOR'S
MESSAGE, HE ASKED THAT WE WORK
WITH THE DTSC, THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL, SO THAT
THE BILL HAD A DEFINED
REGULATORY AGENCY, AND THAT'S
WHAT WE DID IN THIS VERSION. I
ALSO HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS, THOUGH THE OPPOSITION
CONTENDS THAT THIS BILL CONTAINS
NO PROTECTIONS FOR THE
UNINTENTIONAL PFAS. I'D ARGUE
THAT THE BILL, WITH THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN JUNE 24TH,
PROVIDES THEM A REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF PROTECTION VIA THE
NOTICE OF VIOLATION PROCEDURE
OUTLINED IN THE BILL, INCLUDING
THE PRELIMINARY NOTICE
PROCEDURE. WITH ME TODAY AS MY
PRIMARY WITNESS ARE RYAN
SPENCER, ON BEHALF OF THE ACOG,
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS,
AND MISS SHARON GREEN ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT. I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO MISS GREEN. BEFORE WE
GET TO THE WITNESSES, WHY DON'T
I JUST RECITE WHAT I THINK THE
AMENDMENTS ARE? AND I AND I
APOLOGIZE TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT IN THEIR
ANALYSIS, SO JUST TO CLARIFY
YOUR INTENT AND OUR INTENT IS
THAT DTSC IS TO GIVE
MANUFACTURERS 45 DAYS TO
MITIGATE OR TAKE CORRECTIVE
ACTION IF REQUESTED BY DTSC AND
IF THE ENTITY RESPONSIBLE TAKES
THAT CORRECTIVE ACTION, THEN A
VIOLATION IS NOT TO BE ISSUED.
IS THAT YOUR UNDERSTANDING?
THAT'S CORRECT. THERE'S A 45
DAY, WHAT I'LL CALL PRELIMINARY
NOTICE PERIOD, WITHIN WHICH THE
DTSC WILL NOTIFY THE POLLUTER IF
YOU WILL, AND THEY WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECTIFY THE
SITUATION. IF IT IS NOT
RECTIFIED, THEN THE DTSC WILL
ISSUE A FORMAL NOTICE OF
VIOLATION AND WITHIN THAT THERE
COULD BE PENALTIES AS WELL. BUT
YOU GOT THAT REPRIEVE TO BEGIN
WITH. GOT IT. BUT IF THE
CORRECTIVE ACTION IS TAKEN
WITHIN THE 45 DAYS, THEN THERE
IS NO, VIOLATION OR PENALTY BE
ISSUED, CORRECT? RIGHT. NO, NO
FORMAL NOTICE OF VIOLATION AND
NO PENALTY. AND THAT THE AND
DTSC IN ITS SOLE DISCRETION, CAN
ISSUE AN EXTENSION OF THAT 45
DAY PERIOD. THAT'S THE AMENDMENT
THAT WAS REQUESTED LAST NIGHT.
AND THAT IS ACCEPTABLE. OKAY. I
THINK WE ALSO CLARIFIED JUST
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE
CLARIFIED THE FIRST COLLOQUY
BETWEEN THE TWO OF US IS, OKAY,
WHAT THE IMPACT IS, OKAY, ALL
RIGHT. AND THEN ALSO IN
ASSESSING ANY CIVIL PENALTY THAT
A COURT SUBSEQUENTLY, IF A COURT
SHOULD MAKE THAT DECISION, WILL
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE VARIOUS,
FACTORS THAT YOU HAD HAD IN YOUR
BILL FROM LAST YEAR, I BELIEVE
THAT WAS AB 246. CORRECT. OKAY.
THOSE ARE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
TAKEN IN SUBSEQUENT COMMITTEE
AND SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT'S RIGHT. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT. AND THOSE, FACTORS
SET FORTH WHAT A COURT WILL LOOK
AT IN DETERMINING WHETHER OR NOT
TO UPHOLD A PENALTY, ULTIMATELY,
OR WHAT IT SHOULD BE, IF THERE
SHOULD BE ONE. CORRECT. ALL
RIGHT. GOT IT. OKAY. NOW LET'S
TURN TO THE WITNESSES. AND THIS
IS MISS GREEN. PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING. I THINK IT'S STILL
MORNING, CHAIR UMBERG AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, I'M
SHARON GREEN. I'M THE
LEGISLATIVE PROGRAMS MANAGER AT
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICTS OF THE
SANITATION DISTRICTS PROVIDE
WASTEWATER AND SOLID WASTE
SERVICES TO ABOUT 5.5 MILLION
PEOPLE IN 78 CITIES AND
UNINCORPORATED AREAS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. THE SANITATION
DISTRICTS ARE AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT
IS KNOWN AS A PASSIVE RECEIVER
OF PFAS. WE RECEIVE PFAS IN THE
WASTE STREAMS THAT COME FROM THE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT
WE SERVE. WE DO NOT MANUFACTURE
OR ADD PFAS TO OUR TREATMENT
PROCESSES, NOR DO WE HAVE ANY
MANUFACTURERS OF PFAS IN OUR
SERVICE AREA. BUT IF YOU TEST
FOR PFAS, YOU WILL USUALLY FIND
IT IN THE WASTE STREAMS. THAT WE
MANAGE, THIS IS BECAUSE PFAS IS
USED IN SO MANY TYPES OF
PRODUCTS, RANGING FROM COMMON
HOUSEHOLD PRODUCTS TO HIGH TECH
PRODUCTS AND THESE PRODUCTS MAY
BE WASHED OR DISPOSED AND END UP
GOING DOWN THE DRAIN OR BEING
PUT IN THE TRASH. THEY END UP IN
RESIDENTIAL, COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL WASTEWATER, AND THEY
END UP, SHOWING UP AT OUR
MATERIALS RECOVERY OR RECYCLING
FACILITIES. AND FOR ITEMS THAT
CAN'T BE RECYCLED, THEY END UP
IN THE LANDFILLS. SO IN SHORT,
WE WE'RE FINDING THAT PFAS
CHEMICALS ARE UBIQUITOUS AND
FOUND AT LOW BACKGROUND LEVELS
AND WASTEWATER AND SOLID WASTE
FACILITIES EVERYWHERE. SO AB
2515 IS AN IMPORTANT BILL
BECAUSE IT WOULD LIMIT THE USE
OF PFAS AND MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS.
IN ADDITION, TO POTENTIALLY
EXPOSE AND EXPOSING WOMEN TO
PFAS FOR A PORTION OF EVERY
MONTH, WHICH MAY POSE
SUBSTANTIAL HEALTH RISKS, IT IS
PRETTY MUCH GUARANTEED THAT
THESE PRODUCTS OR THEIR
PACKAGING, AND WHATEVER PFAS
THEY CONTAIN, WILL ENTER THE
WASTEWATER AND SOLID WASTE
STREAM AND CONTRIBUTE TO THE
OVERALL LEVELS OF PFAS AT WASTE
AND WASTEWATER FACILITIES AND
ULTIMATELY REACHING THE
ENVIRONMENT. THE SANITATION
DISTRICTS BELIEVE THAT
ELIMINATING NON-ESSENTIAL AND
INCIDENTAL USES OF PFAS IN
CONSUMER AND INDUSTRIAL PRODUCTS
IS KEY TO REDUCING PFAS IN THE
WATER CYCLE AND IN THE
ENVIRONMENT MORE BROADLY. THE
FIRST STEP TO ADDRESSING THIS
UBIQUITOUS CHEMICAL PROBLEM AND
PROTECTING OUR INDIVIDUAL
HEALTH. AND I ASSUME YOU URGE
AND I VOTE YES, I DO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. NEXT
WITNESS, RYAN SPENCER, ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OB-GYN DISTRICT NINE, I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT ACOG HAS LONG
EXPRESSED THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT
THE EFFECTS OF EXPOSURE TO
ENVIRONMENTAL CHEMICALS,
INCLUDING PFAS, TO WOMEN AND
BIRTHING INDIVIDUALS, ESPECIALLY
IN PRODUCTS SUCH AS MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS. AND IT'S REALLY FOR
ALL THE REASONS STATED BY THE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN AND THE PREVIOUS
WITNESS. AND SO WITH THAT, I'LL
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB 2515,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
NAME, POSITION, AFFILIATION.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS ALFREDO ARREDONDO AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE IRVINE
RANCH WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SPENCER SACKS, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, LEAH JONES,
ON BEHALF OF A VOICE FOR CHOICE
ADVOCACY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HELLO KELLY MCMILLAN,
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMISSION ON
THE STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS.
THANK YOU. SARAH BOUDREAU WITH
THE CITY OF ROSEVILLE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, JENNIFER
CAPETILLO, CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, SYMPHONY BARBIE, ON BEHALF
OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, ALYSSA
SALEHI ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA ROSA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT, NOW WE'LL TURN TO
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 2515, YOU MAY EITHER SIT AT
THE TABLE OR APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. THANK YOU. GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS.
DAWN KOEPKE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND
REGRETFUL OPPOSITION, THAT SAID,
WE DO APPRECIATE THE CHAIR AND
THE COMMITTEE'S CONVERSATIONS
AND DEEP ENGAGEMENT ON THE
ISSUES AND JUST KIND OF AS TO
LEVEL SET IN TERMS OF CMTA S
OPPOSITION. AND TO BE CLEAR,
RIGHT OUT OF THE GATE, CMTA
MEMBER COMPANIES FOR THESE
PRODUCTS DO NOT ADD THESE
CHEMICALS FOR ANY PURPOSE
WHATSOEVER. IF THESE CHEMICALS
EXIST IN THESE PRODUCTS, IT IS
BASED PURELY ON TRACE,
UNAVOIDABLE CONTAMINATION. NOW
ALL THAT SAID, WE, YOU KNOW, DO
CERTAINLY HAVE CONCERNS AT A TEN
PARTS PER MILLION AND OUR
ABILITY TO CONTROL FOR THAT,
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE UBIQUITY OF
THESE CHEMICALS. NOW OUR
MANUFACTURERS CAN DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT
WHERE THEY'RE SOURCING THEIR RAW
MATERIALS FROM, IN TERMS OF
COTTON, MUCH LESS, YOU KNOW, DUE
DILIGENCE AS PART OF WIPING DOWN
MANUFACTURING LINES. WHAT HAVE
YOU. BUT WE ARE NOT CERTAIN,
AGAIN, GIVEN THE UBIQUITY OF
THESE CHEMICALS THAT WE CAN KEEP
THOSE TRACE UNAVOIDABLE LEVELS
BELOW TEN PPM. AND THAT IS THE
FUNDAMENTAL REASON FOR OUR
CONCERNS ASSOCIATED IMPAIRED
WITH THE CONCERNS AROUND
SIGNIFICANT LIABILITY AND
ENFORCEMENT. NOW, WE APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATIONS AS PART OF THE
AMENDMENTS TODAY. IT STILL DOES
REMAIN SOMEWHAT UNCLEAR TO US
WITH REGARD TO THE ABILITY FOR
DTSC TO REQUIRE CORRECTIVE
ACTION MANUFACTURERS TO
UNDERTAKE THAT. CERTAINLY, THE
MANUFACTURERS ARE OPEN TO THAT.
I THINK THE QUESTION JUST
BECOMES IF THEY UNDERTAKE
CORRECTIVE ACTION PER DSK'S
REQUEST AND IT STILL COMES BACK
ABOVE TEN PPM AS UNAVOIDABLE, IS
THAT STILL A VIOLATION? THAT IS
A FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION THAT I
THINK STILL REMAINS.
ADDITIONALLY, IN TERMS OF THE
PUBLIC NOTICE, THAT'S CONTAINED
WITHIN THE BILL, THAT ALSO IS A
VERY CONCERNING. TYPICALLY,
AGENCIES ARE THE ONES THAT
PROVIDE THE PUBLIC NOTICES WHEN
A VIOLATION OCCURS. HOWEVER, THE
BILL ALSO PROVIDES THAT A
MANUFACTURER WOULD HAVE TO POST
NOT ONLY ON ITS WEBSITE, ALSO ON
ITS SOCIAL MEDIA PAGES REGARDING
A VIOLATION, AND AGAIN, THIS
WOULD BE A VIOLATION FOR
UNAVOIDABLE TRACE CONTAMINANTS.
SO THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF CONCERN REGARDING POTENTIAL
LIABILITY UNDER FALSE
ADVERTISING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YOU URGE A NO VOTE. WE
URGE A NO VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
GREAT. THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
AND LET ME LET ME DO A LITTLE
HOUSEKEEPING HERE. WE'VE GOT
LATE BREAKING NEWS AND THAT LATE
BREAKING NEWS IS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE ASSEMBLY ARE
GOING TO CAUCUS, APPARENTLY
RIGHT NOW. SO THAT THAT CREATES
A CHALLENGE FOR US, WE HAVE ONE
REPUBLICAN BILL UP TODAY, AND
WE'LL HEAR THAT BILL, I SUPPOSE.
IN SHORT ORDER. BUT AND WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PACHECO'S, MATTER, AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO BREAK AND I'M NOT
SURE EXACTLY HOW LONG WE'RE
GOING TO BREAK FOR, BUT WE'RE
GOING TO BREAK. SO, I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT, BUT I KNOW A LOT OF
FOLKS ARE VERY INTERESTED IN
WHAT OUR SCHEDULE IS GOING TO
BE, SO. OKAY. NEXT WITNESS,
PLEASE. THANK YOU. CHAIRMAN
BERGER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'LL KEEP THIS REALLY
SHORT. LAUREN AGUILAR, ON BEHALF
OF THE CENTER FOR BABY AND ADULT
HYGIENE PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION, WE
ARE ALSO REGRETFULLY, IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL, AND I
ECHO EVERYTHING THAT MY
COLLEAGUE DON SAID. I JUST WANT
TO ALSO SAY AGAIN, THAT OUR
MEMBERS ARE NOT INTENTIONALLY
ADDING PFAS TO OUR PRODUCTS AND
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE INTENT
OF THE BILL. BUT WE STILL DO
HAVE SOME GENERAL CONCERNS
AROUND THE PUBLIC NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS, AS WELL AS THE
PENALTIES BEING EXTREMELY HIGH
FOR THE SCOPE OF VIOLATION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. YES, THIS
IS FOR THE ME TOS IN THE
OPPOSITION. CORRECT? I'M AND I
AM YOUR TEMPORARY INTERIM CHAIR.
GOT IT. I'M BILL ALEO WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP IN
AN AWKWARD POSITION BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN SUPPORTING AND
SPONSORING PFAS BILLS FOR A FEW
YEARS NOW. I'M ALSO REPRESENTING
NRDC CLEAN WATER ACTION BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS,
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER ATTORNEYS,
CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH,
WHERE WE PUT A LATE LETTER IN
OPPOSED MONDAY BECAUSE WE JUST
GOT THE AMENDMENT THAT THE CHAIR
DESCRIBED ABOUT THE RIGHT TO
CURE. AND YOU WON'T GET A
VIOLATION. I'M LETTING YOU GO.
BUT THIS IS A PRETTY WORDY. ME,
TOO. THAT'S IT. BECAUSE OF THE
RIGHT TO CURE, WE'RE KIND OF
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED. AND
WE'LL WORK WITH THE AUTHOR.
OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. JULIE MALINOWSKI, ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL, ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE
BY CMTA. OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANKS. ANNALEE AUGUSTINE, ON
BEHALF OF CONSUMER BRANDS
ASSOCIATION. ALSO IN OPPOSITION,
SEEING NO OTHER METOOS IN
OPPOSITION, WE'RE GOING TO BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. I
UNDERSTAND SENATOR ROTH HAS A
QUESTION. I'M JUST CURIOUS ABOUT
THE TEN PARTS PER MILLION. HOW
DID WE GET TO THAT? WELL, IT'S
ALREADY WHAT OCCURS IN EUROPE,
AND THAT YOU CAN TEST AT TEN
PARTS PER MILLION. SO THAT'S WHY
WE GOT DOWN TO THAT, THAT LEVEL.
AND SO GIVEN THE FACT THAT IT'S
THE UNINTENTIONAL PIECE OF THIS
THAT IS OF CONCERN TO ME AND HOW
DID WE WHAT DOES ANYONE KNOW?
WHAT'S THE STANDARD IN WATER FOR
WATER MUCH LOWER. IF I MAY,
SENATOR. SO IN TERMS OF
STANDARDS FOR WATER, NOTABLY THE
PFAS CLASS OF CHEMICALS IS
THOUSANDS OF CHEMICALS WIDE AND
DEEP. AS YOU MAY BE AWARE. SO
OVER 3000 SOME ESTIMATES ARE
HIGHER THAN THAT IN TERMS OF
WATER AND ACTUAL MAXIMUM
CONTAMINANT LEVELS FOR PFAS AND
DRINKING WATER. THERE HAVE ONLY
BEEN JUST A SMALL SUBSET OF
THOSE THAT HAVE ACTUALLY HAD
STANDARDS SET. SO LARGELY FOR
PFOA AND PFOS TO PARTICULAR,
PFAS CHEMICALS THAT ARE INDEED
VERY MUCH KNOWN TO HAVE
CHALLENGES, VERY SIGNIFICANT
EFFECTS. SO BUT THERE ARE NOT
DRINKING WATER STANDARDS FOR THE
THOUSANDS OF CHEMICALS WITHIN
THE PFAS CLASS. SO IMPORTANT
THOSE TWO IN PARTICULAR ARE VERY
LOW, BUT WE WOULD ARGUE LOWER
THAN TEN PARTS PER MILLION. YES.
YES, SIR. POINT ZERO TWO PARTS
PER MILLION. OKAY. BUT AGAIN,
NOT ALL HAVE BEEN CLASSIFIED,
MUCH LESS HAVE STANDARDS SET FOR
THEM. AND THE UNINTENTIONAL
DOESN'T KICK IN UNTIL TWO YEARS
FROM NOW TO ALLOW SOME
OPPORTUNITY TO COVER AND TO
AVOID ANYTHING THAT YOU MIGHT
NOT HAVE SEEN ALONG THE WAY. I
MEAN, MY CONCERN WAS MANY
MANUFACTURING PLANTS PLUG INTO
THE WATER SUPPLY, WHETHER IT'S A
MUNICIPAL SUPPLY OR A SUPPLY
FROM SOMEBODY ELSE. AND, YOU
KNOW, YOU DON'T HAVE MUCH
CONTROL OVER WHAT COMES IN THE
WATER PIPE THAT'S USED IN THE
MANUFACTURING PROCESS. BUT IF
THE IF THE WATER STANDARD IS
0.02 PARTS PER MILLION, AND
WE'RE TALKING TEN PARTS PER
MILLION HERE, PRESUMABLY THE
WATER IS GOING TO COME IN PRETTY
CLOSE TO ZERO TWO PARTS PER
MILLION, OR WE GOT A PROBLEM.
AND THEN SINCE PFAS OR PFAS
RELATED CHEMICALS ARE PRESENT
EVERYWHERE, INCLUDING IN US, HOW
DO WE AND YOU'RE USING COTTON
AND OTHER FABRICS TO MAKE THE
PRODUCTS THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
HERE. AND THOSE ARE GROWN
SOMEWHERE. AND PRESUMABLY WHAT'S
IN THE DIRT AND THE WATER GETS
IN THE PRODUCT. HOW DO WE HOW DO
YOU CONTROL THAT? THEREIN DOES
LIE CHALLENGES. CERTAINLY,
SENATOR, I WOULD ALSO JUST GO
BACK TO, IN TERMS OF THE
DRINKING WATER STANDARD BEING
FAR BELOW TEN PPM. AGAIN, THAT'S
ONLY FOR JUST 2 OR 3 PARTICULAR
PFAS CHEMICALS WITHIN A CLASS OF
THOUSANDS. SO I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE. BUT IN TERMS
OF YOUR POINT AROUND SOURCING
COTTON RAW MATERIALS,
ABSOLUTELY. GIVEN THE UBIQUITY
OF THESE CHEMICALS IN A VERY
DEEP NUMBER OF CHEMICALS WITHIN
THE CLASS, YOU'RE TAKING THOSE
CHEMICALS IN TERMS OF UPTAKE IN
WATER INTO THE COTTON THROUGH
THE SOILS, WHAT HAVE YOU. AND SO
THAT MAY NOT BE ABLE TO BE
MITIGATED IN FULL. AND WHEN YOU
PICK UP A PPM HERE AND THERE
THROUGHOUT THAT PROCESS, EVEN IF
WE, YOU KNOW, TRIED TO SOURCE,
YOU KNOW, OUR COTTON FROM, YOU
KNOW, KIND OF DIFFERENT FARMS,
WHAT HAVE YOU, THERE IS NOT
CERTAINTY THAT WE CAN KEEP THAT
LEVEL THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
SUPPLY CHAIN. AND MANUFACTURING
CHAIN DOWN BELOW TEN PPM. EVEN
IF WE WERE TO DO OUR DUE
DILIGENCE IN SOURCING, WIPING
DOWN MANUFACTURING LINES FROM
LUBRICANTS THAT MAY HAVE PFAS,
WHAT HAVE YOU. SO IT'S
CHALLENGING AND THAT LIABILITY
ENFORCEMENT IS OF CONCERN GIVEN
THOSE CHALLENGES, IS THERE A
PROCESS IN PLACE NOW? WHAT'S THE
PROCESS TO TEST FOR PFAS IN IN
TEXTILE MATERIAL FOR EXAMPLE. SO
HISTORICALLY MANUFACTURERS HAVE
NOT HAD TO TEST FOR THINGS THAT
THEY'RE NOT ADDING TO THEIR
PRODUCTS. SO AGAIN, AS I STATED
OUT OF THE GATE, SENATOR, THEY
ARE NOT ADDING PFAS CHEMICALS TO
THESE PRODUCTS FOR ANY REASON.
AND WE HAVE NOT HAD A NEED OR A
REASON TO HAVE TO TEST FOR
THINGS THAT WERE NOT ADDING.
THAT SAID, MANUFACTURERS
RECOGNIZE THERE ARE CONCERNS AND
ARE CERTAINLY OPEN TO DOING MORE
IN TERMS OF DUE DILIGENCE TO TRY
TO MITIGATE CONTAMINANTS WHERE
POSSIBLE, BUT IT IS NOT CERTAIN
THAT IT'S UNAVOIDABLE. AT TEN
ABOVE TEN, I ASSUME TESTING IS
PRACTICABLE. I MEAN, YOU CAN
TEST RAW MATERIALS SUCH AS
COTTON. YES. THE CHALLENGE THERE
THERE IS VARIABILITY AMONG
COTTON FIELDS AND UPTAKES.
FURTHER, AS PART OF THE LANGUAGE
WITHIN THE BILL THAT REQUIRES A
TEST THAT IS A TOTAL ORGANIC
FLUORINE TEST. THAT TEST IS A
COMBUSTION TEST, WHICH
ESSENTIALLY MEANS YOU HAVE TO
LIGHT EITHER THE COTTON OR THE
END PRODUCT ON ON FIRE TO TEST
FOR THE PRESENCE OF PFAS, WHICH
MAKES IT CHALLENGING TO TEST
EVERY SINGLE TAMPON OR PAD WHEN
IT'S BEING PUT INTO COMMERCE,
AND BE ABLE TO KNOW IF IT'S
BELOW. BECAUSE OF THE UBIQUITY,
UBIQUITY OF THESE CHEMICALS AND
VARIABILITY IN THOSE
MANUFACTURING PROCESSES. FROM
ONE TAMPON IN A BOX TO ANOTHER,
AND WHETHER THERE MAY BE
DIFFERENT LEVELS BETWEEN THOSE
HAVING SPENT A LOT OF TIME IN
GEORGIA, I GUESS IT DEPENDS ON
WHAT PART OF THE FIELD THE
COTTONS PICK FROM. TRUE,
DEPENDING ON HOW LARGE THE FIELD
. YES. WELL, THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY
SOME COMPLICATIONS WITH THIS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I, YOU KNOW,
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL,
BUT I THINK AS THIS MOVES
FORWARD, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
FIGURE IT OUT BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW HOW A MANUFACTURER THAT
WATER IS ONE THING, BECAUSE YOU
CAN TEST IT AT THE TIME THAT IT
COMES INTO YOUR MANUFACTURING
PLANT. PRESUMABLY THE WATER
SUPPLIERS ARE DOING THE SAME
THING AND KEEPING IT BELOW THE
STANDARD THAT WE ALL SAY NEEDS
TO BE. BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE GROWN IN
FIELDS THAT USE WATER FROM OTHER
PLACES AND OR SUCK UP WHATEVER
IS IN THE DIRT FROM WHO KNOWS
WHEN. AND FIELDS ARE LARGE AND
YOU DON'T. AND YOU MAY, YOU MAY
SPOT CHECK. BUT YOU KNOW, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PROCESS
WOULD BE TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
SPOT CHECK ENOUGH TO ENSURE THAT
YOU HAVE A PALLET OR A SERIES OF
PALLETS OF COTTON THAT ARE GOING
TO GO INTO THE MANUFACTURING
PROCESS THAT MEETS YOUR
STANDARDS. SO WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO THINK THROUGH THAT A
LITTLE COMPLICATED FOR THIS
HEARING. SO. WELL, IF I MAY, IF
I MAY, WHICH IS WHY WE PUT THE
45 DAY PRELIMINARY NOTICE
PROCEDURE IN THE BILL, BECAUSE
WE'VE HEARD ALL ALONG ABOUT THIS
UNINTENTIONAL WE HAVEN'T DONE
ANYTHING. SO I DID TWO THINGS TO
TRY TO ACCOMMODATE THOSE
CONCERNS. NUMBER ONE IS TWO
YEARS UNTIL IT KICKS IN. NUMBER
TWO IS IF IN FACT THE DTSC FINDS
SOMETHING BY DOING THEIR
SAMPLING AS THEY DO OUT IN THE,
YOU KNOW, THEY'LL JUST TAKE A
SAMPLING THAT'S OUT IN THE
UNIVERSE, IF YOU WILL, AND THEY
FIND SOMETHING, YOU'VE GOT 45
DAYS AS A MANUFACTURER TO GET A
HOLD OF WHAT'S GOING ON. AND IF
YOU DON'T ONLY THEN DOES THE
NOTICE OF VIOLATION KICK IN AND
PENALTIES KICK IN BECAUSE THE
PUBLIC'S GOT TO KNOW. SO THAT'S
WHY WE ACCOMMODATE THAT. I'VE
BEEN DOWN THIS ROAD FOR TWO
YEARS NOW WITH WE DON'T
INTENTIONALLY PUT IT IN, BUT WE
MIGHT HAVE INTENTIONAL I HEARD
YOU AND THIS IS THE PROCEDURE
THAT WE CAME UP WITH. AND I
THINK IT'S A REASONABLE
PROCEDURE TO A LOT FOR THOSE
UNCERTAINTIES. AS A
MANUFACTURER. AND THE GOOD NEWS
IS, SOME OF US WILL BE GOING
AWAY, BUT YOU WILL BE HERE. AND
SO I'M, I'M CONFIDENT THAT
YOU'RE SAYING WHAT YOU SAID
YOU'RE COMMITTING TO ME TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THIS. AND IF IT PROVES
RATHER, UNWORKABLE FOR THE
MANUFACTURING SECTOR BECAUSE
THIS IS A PRETTY ESSENTIAL
PRODUCT. YES. WE'LL HAVE TO
FIGURE SOMETHING ELSE OUT, AND I
KNOW YOU'LL DO IT. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. YES, QUESTIONS FROM
ANY OTHER MEMBER, I WOULD JUST
MAKE A COMMENT. AND THAT IS EVEN
THOUGH IT'S WATER BASED, I HAD
THE EXPERIENCE WHEN I WAS FIRST
IN THE ASSEMBLY OF THE
PERCHLORATE SPILL OUT OF MORGAN
HILL, WHERE, HIGHWAY SAFETY
FLARE PLANT HAD BEEN THROWING IT
IN THE GROUND FOR 30 OR 40 OR 50
YEARS, AND IT WENT TO A NINE
MILE PLUME. THE POINT BEING,
THAT'S ON POINT HERE. THERE WAS
REGULAR TESTING, AND IT WAS
RIGHT AT THE TIME THAT THE, THE
TESTING STANDARD, THE SCIENCE
DROPPED TO BE ABLE TO DETECT IT
AT A MUCH HIGHER LEVEL. AND THEY
WOULD DO TESTS EVERY THREE
MONTHS. AND SOMETIMES WELLS
WOULD BE JUST IN CONTAMINATION.
AND THE NEXT TIME THEY MIGHT BE
JUST OUTSIDE THE LEVEL. AND
BECAUSE THERE WAS REGULAR
TESTING AND BECAUSE IT WAS A NO
PUN INTENDED FLUID SITUATION, IT
WAS JUST DIFFERENT IN HOW THEY
DID IT. AND SO IT'S A QUESTION
AND I KNOW THAT THAT SOME OF
WHAT SENATOR ROTH WAS ASKING
ABOUT WAS NOT WATER BASED, BUT
IT'S JUST A QUESTION OF HOW BEST
TO DO THAT OVER TIME. AND
HOPEFULLY THAT'S WHAT THE TWO
YEARS IS, IS USED FOR, IS TO
DETERMINE THAT. AND SOME OF THE
TEXTILES ARE ON IT AS WELL. YOU
KNOW, YOU'RE YOU'RE STARTING TO
GET MORE REGULATION AT THE
TEXTILE LEVEL AS WELL. SO THAT
SHOULD HELP US ALONG THE WAY. OH
YOU'RE GOING TO BE BUSY THE REST
OF YOUR, TERMS, I DON'T HAVE A
MOTION YET, BUT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I JUST RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. I THINK
WE'VE GOTTEN TO A PLACE ON THIS
BILL THAT, MAKES IT WORKABLE,
AND I. I LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING
IT ALONG. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MOTION BY
ROTH, WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL? MRS. FILE ITEM NUMBER 20,
AB 2515. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. BERG
WILK ALLEN. ASHBY. CABALLERO
DURAZZO. LAIRD. AYE. LAIRD. AYE
MILO. ROTH ROTH. AYE. STERN.
WAHAB. 2 TO 0 2 TO 0. WE WILL
PLACE THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, SENATOR PACHECO HAS,
BEEN PATIENTLY WAITING. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM 21,
ASSEMBLY BILL 1160, BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PACHECO. AND IF ANYBODY
IS IN THE HALLWAY AND INTENDS TO
TESTIFY, PLEASE COME IN THE ROOM
AND GET READY TO DO THAT. SO,
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU. AND
HELLO, MR. CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. TODAY I PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 1160. I'D LIKE TO
THANK COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL, AND I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. THESE AMENDMENTS, IN
ADDITION TO AMENDMENTS TAKEN
LAST WEEK, REFLECT MONTHS OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH OPPOSITION
AND GOOD FAITH EFFORTS TO
MITIGATE CONCERNS. WHILE
ENSURING THAT OUR GOAL TO
PROTECT STUDENTS FROM THE HARMS
OF INSTITUTIONAL DEBT REMAIN
INTACT. LET ME BE CLEAR AB 1160
PRESERVES TOOLS FOR COLLEGES TO
COLLECT DEBT, COLLECT DEBT, AND
BRING IN REVENUE. THE BILL DOES
NOT CANCEL INSTITUTIONAL DEBT,
NOR REQUIRE COLLEGES TO DO SO.
IT DOES NOT ABSOLVE ABSOLVE
STUDENTS OF THEIR REPAYMENT
RESPONSIBILITIES. INSTEAD, AB
1160 HELPS STUDENTS SUCCEED
ACADEMICALLY AND PROFESSIONALLY
WHILE INCREASING COLLEGES
CHANCES OF DEBT. COLLECTION. THE
BILL INTRODUCES A ONE TIME GRACE
PERIOD FOR STUDENTS TO REENROLL
AND MAKE PROGRESS TOWARDS THEIR
DEGREES, WHILE WORKING TO REPAY
THEIR INSTITUTIONAL DEBT,
STUDENTS MUST PAY FOR THE
CURRENT TERM AND SETTLE THEIR
DEBT BY PAYING IT OFF OR
ENTERING A PAYMENT PLAN BY THE
END OF THAT TERM. TO CONTINUE
ENROLLING AFTER THE GRACE
PERIOD. THE BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES SAFEGUARDS ON THE
USE OF FOR PROFIT THIRD PARTY
DEBT COLLECTION. SCHOOLS MUST
WAIT 180 DAYS BEFORE SUBJECTING
STUDENTS TO COLLECTIONS OR
REPORTING NEGATIVE MARKS ON
DEBT. ON STUDENTS CREDIT
REPORTS. THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
SCHOOLS TO COMMUNICATE TO
STUDENTS THE SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL CONSEQUENCES OF BEING
SUBJECT TO COLLECTIONS. THESE
PROVISIONS ALIGN STUDENT DEBT
COLLECTION PROTECTIONS WITH
THOSE FOR MEDICAL AND OTHER
DEBTS UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW.
ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL SHEDS
LIGHT ON THIS UNDER-REGULATED
MARKET OF SCHOOL OWNED SCHOOL
OWED DEBTS BY REQUIRING SCHOOLS
TO REPORT THEIR DEBTS AND
COLLECTION PRACTICES AS
REQUESTED FROM STAKEHOLDERS. WE
HAVE AMENDED THE BILL
SIGNIFICANTLY TO PROVIDE MORE
TIME AND FEWER REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS, ENSURING THAT
SCHOOLS HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
COLLECT AND REPORT DATA
ADEQUATELY. I HAVE MAINTAINED AN
OPEN DOOR POLICY FOR
STAKEHOLDERS, AND AS YOU CAN SEE
IN THE BILL'S TWO YEAR HISTORY,
I HAVE TAKEN NUMEROUS AMENDMENTS
AND DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS. NEW IDEAS
WERE PRESENTED LEADING UP TO
TODAY'S HEARING, BUT I REMAIN
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
THROUGH WITH THOSE WITH THE
OPPOSITION. THE CURRENT VERSION
OF THE BILL REFLECTS A STRONG
MIDDLE GROUND THAT WILL BE
WORKABLE FOR INSTITUTIONS AND,
MOST IMPORTANTLY, PROTECT
STUDENTS. THE INSTITUTIONAL DEBT
CRISIS HAS LONG BEEN OVERLOOKED.
DURING THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
THE COVID PANDEMIC, MORE THAN
750,000 LOW INCOME STUDENTS OWED
MORE THAN 390 MILLION TO
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC COLLEGES. WE
CAN, AND WE MUST DO MORE TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. THE
BILL PRESENTED TODAY IS A
COMPROMISE, BUT IT WILL BENEFIT
STUDENTS AND COLLEGES ALIKE,
TODAY I HAVE TWO WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 1160. I
HAVE ALYSSA CANCHOLA BAINES.
BAINES POLICY DIRECTOR AT THE
STUDENT BORROWER PROTECTION
PROTECTION CENTER. AND I ALSO
HAVE PROFESSOR CHARLIE EATON,
ASSISTANT ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
SOCIOLOGY AT UC MERCED. NOW HAND
IT OVER TO THEM. THANK YOU.
FIRST WITNESS. GREAT HELLO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR. CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
ALYSSA CANCELA, AND I SERVE AS
THE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
STUDENT BORROWER PROTECTION
CENTER. WE ARE A NATIONAL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WORKING
TO ADVANCE STATE AND NATIONAL
POLICIES TO ALLEVIATE THE BURDEN
OF STUDENT DEBT. WE'RE PROUD
CO-SPONSORS OF AB 1160 AND THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHECO FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND WILLINGNESS
REALLY TO WORK ALONGSIDE US. TO
ENSURE THAT THIS BILL IS
WORKABLE, BUT ALSO PROTECT
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES, UNLIKE
THE NATIONAL STUDENT DEBT CRISIS
THAT'S REALLY DOMINATED THE
HEADLINES OVER THE RECENT YEARS.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED
, INSTITUTIONAL DEBT HAS LARGELY
GONE OVERLOOKED. THESE DEBTS
OFTEN ACCRUE WHEN EMERGENCIES
FORCE STUDENTS TO WITHDRAW
MID-TERM, LARGELY DUE TO PUBLIC
HEALTH OR FINANCIAL EMERGENCIES,
AND UNFORTUNATELY, THEY LACK THE
VARIOUS CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND
TRANSPARENCY REQUIREMENTS
AFFORDED TO BORROWERS UNDER
FEDERAL LAW. AND OVER THE COURSE
OF THE PANDEMIC, WE BEGAN TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
CONSEQUENCES AND IMPACTS OF
INSTITUTIONAL DEBT. RESEARCHERS
ACROSS THE UC SYSTEM HAD FOUND
THAT SCHOOLS WERE USING BOTH
TRADITIONAL THIRD PARTY DEBT
COLLECTORS TO RECOVER THESE
DEBTS, BUT ALSO USE TACTICS
UNAVAILABLE TO, EXCUSE ME TO
MOST CREDITORS, LIKE PREVENTING
STUDENTS FROM RE-ENROLLING IN
THEIR EDUCATION AND REFERRING
STUDENTS TO TAX BENEFIT OFFSET,
WHICH DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMS
CALIFORNIA'S LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS. WHILE AB 1160 WILL
PROTECT STUDENTS FROM MANY OF
THESE HARMS, IT WILL ALSO ALLOW
SCHOOLS TO MAINTAIN COLLECTION
TOOLS AS A LAST RESORT. AB 1160
GIVES STUDENTS THE CHANCE TO
REENROLL TO GET BACK ON CAMPUS
WHILE THEY WORK WITH
ADMINISTRATORS TO REPAY THEIR
INSTITUTIONAL DEBT OR ENROLL IN
A PAYMENT PLAN. STUDENTS WILL
BENEFIT BY GETTING BACK ON
TRACK, AND SCHOOLS WILL COLLECT
NEW TUITION WHILE COLLECTING THE
OWED DEBT AND AS PROFESSOR EATON
WILL TESTIFY, THESE PROVISIONS
ACTUALLY MAKE THE BILL REVENUE
POSITIVE FOR SCHOOLS. WHEN
IMPLEMENTED, IT ESTABLISHES
COMMON SENSE GUARDRAILS FOR THE
USE OF THIRD PARTY DEBT
COLLECTORS THAT MIRROR EXISTING
STANDARDS IN CALIFORNIA AND
PREVENTS STUDENTS FROM BEING
SUBJECT TO TAX OFFSET FOR TWO
YEARS AFTER LEAVING CAMPUS,
PROTECTING THEM DURING A CRUCIAL
TIME WHEN STUDIES SHOW THEY'RE
MOST LIKELY TO RETURN TO CAMPUS
AND COMPLETE THEIR DEGREE. AND
LAST BUT NOT LEAST, THE BILL
REQUIRES DATA AND TRANSPARENCY,
SO POLICY MAKERS ASSUME YOURS
AND I VOTE YES. I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE, I VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, I AM
CHARLIE EATON. I'M AN ECONOMIC
SOCIOLOGIST AND PROFESSOR AT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA,
MERCED, WHERE I COFOUNDED THE
HIGHER EDUCATION RACE AND THE
ECONOMY LAB. OUR LAB COAUTHORED
THE CREDITOR COLLEGES STUDY OF
INSTITUTIONAL STUDENT DEBT WITH
UC IRVINE LAW PROFESSOR DALIA
JIMENEZ AND BERKELEY LAW
PROFESSOR JONATHAN GLAZER.
INSTITUTIONAL DEBTS WORK
DIFFERENTLY THAN STUDENT LOANS,
AND THEY TEND TO BE MORE
HARMFUL. WE ESTIMATE THAT
300,000, MOSTLY LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS INCUR THESE
DEBTS IN AN AVERAGE YEAR, AND
CURRENTLY ONLY AROUND 25% OF
THESE DEBTS ARE EVER REPAID.
BECAUSE STUDENTS LACK THE MEANS,
AB 1160 WILL HELP THOUSANDS OF
THESE STUDENTS TO COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION, AND IT WILL ALSO HELP
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS
BRING IN ADDITIONAL REVENUE TO
SERVE STUDENTS. HERE'S WHY. MOST
STUDENTS INCUR THESE DEBTS WHEN
THEY WITHDRAW FROM SCHOOL IN THE
MIDDLE OF AN ACADEMIC TERM,
BECAUSE OF A HEALTH OR ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP, SCHOOLS ARE THEN
REQUIRED TO RETURN SOME OF THESE
STUDENTS PELL GRANTS AND STUDENT
LOAN AID TO THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. MOST SCHOOLS THEN
PLACE REGISTRATION HOLDS THAT
BAR FURTHER ENROLLMENT UNTIL
STUDENTS REPAY THEIR FEDERAL AID
TO THE SCHOOL. AB 1160 IS
AMENDED, WOULD GRANT STUDENTS A
ONE TIME GRACE PERIOD TO
REENROLL FOR THE ACADEMIC TERM
AFTER INCURRING THE DEBT, AND,
AS AMENDED, AB 1160 WOULD ALSO
ESTABLISH A TWO YEAR GRACE
PERIOD FROM TAX REFUND OFFSETS
FOR DEBTS. TOGETHER, THESE
AMENDMENTS WOULD ALLOW STUDENTS
TO ARRANGE A PAYMENT PLAN FOR
WHAT THEY OWE WHILE CONTINUING
PROGRESS TOWARDS THEIR DEGREE.
SEVERAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
CSU'S AND UC'S, INCLUDING MY
OWN, HAVE ALREADY DEMONSTRATED
SUCCESS WITH THIS APPROACH IN
RECENT YEARS, BUT MOST SCHOOLS
HAVE RESISTED THESE BENEFICIAL
PRACTICES. CONTRARY TO SOME
MISUNDERSTANDINGS, AB 1160 WILL
NOT CREATE A LOOPHOLE FOR
STUDENTS TO GET OUT OF PAYING
TUITION. THIS IS BECAUSE AB 1160
PRESERVES SCHOOLS DROPPED FOR
NONPAYMENT POLICIES AND SOME AB
1160, AS AMENDED, TAKES A
BALANCED APPROACH TO PROTECT
STUDENTS WHILE HELPING SCHOOLS
KEEP THEM ENROLLED. WHEN
HARDSHIPS CREATE UNEXPECTED
DEBTS. THANKS, AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
GIVE US YOUR NAME, YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION,
CAROLINE NGUYEN WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA STUDENT
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE PROUD TO
CO-SPONSOR, ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
OUR COLLEAGUES OVER AT YOU
ASPIRE. THANK YOU. DAVID RAMIREZ
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SELENA DEAN,
PRESIDENT OF THE BIÂU CSA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MARIA MENDEZ
, VICE CHAIR OF UCSA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, KELLY
O'BRIEN WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI CAROL
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF LONG BEACH
CITY COLLEGE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, NICO MASON WITH
THE MESA VERDE GROUP, ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. DANNY KENDALL KAISER, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CYNTHIA GÓMEZ, DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF STATE POLICY AND
ADVOCACY WITH THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, ILMA
ESCOBAR, WITH CHIRLA. I SUPPORT
THANK YOU, MISS STAIGER, WITH
CFT, A UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BRIAN
PORTIO, UC DAVIS STUDENT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. KEVIN
SANCHEZ, UC DAVIS STUDENT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, RUTH BARTHA,
ON BEHALF OF YOUNG INVINCIBLES
AND STUDENT DEBT RELIEF CRISIS
CENTER, A PROUD CO-SPONSORS A
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB 1160. THANK
YOU. SAMANTHA. STAYING WITH NEXT
GEN CALIFORNIA Ã REPRESENTING
ACTION CALIFORNIA CO-SPONSOR
STRONG SUPPORT ALSO ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMER REPORTS CO-SPONSOR AND
STRONG SUPPORT. AND CALIFORNIA
COMPETES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHES THE MICROPHONE. LET'S
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 1160,
PLEASE EITHER COME TO THE TABLE
OR APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. I'M
SORRY. SURE I'LL ASK ONE OF YOU
TO WRITE TO VACATE FOR A MOMENT
AT LEAST. ALL RIGHT. GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M MAGGIE WHITE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
I AM HERE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB 1160, AND I'LL
BE TALKING FAST. I, I'D FIRST
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PACHECO AND THE SPONSORS FOR
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH US. WE
HAVE HAD MULTIPLE PRODUCTIVE
INTERACTIONS SINCE THE LAST
HEARING. THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE HAS
SHARED THAT THEY ARE WILLING TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH US ON OUR
REMAINING CONCERNS. I FEEL
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN GET TO A
GOOD PLACE IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO SINCERELY THANK
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THE BILL. AFTER THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE, WE OFFERED
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE COMPILED BY
ALL OF THE SEGMENTS THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION. THE AMENDMENTS WOULD
HAVE REMOVED OUR CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL, WHILE STILL ADVANCING
SOME OF THE ORIGINAL BILL'S
PRIORITIES. AMENDMENTS TAKEN
LAST WEEK DID TOUCH ON SOME
ISSUE AREAS FOR US, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY DID NOT RESOLVE
THEM FULLY. IN OUR EYES, THIS
BILL TOUCHES ON EVERY INTERNAL
AND EXTERNAL METHOD OF DEBT
COLLECTION AVAILABLE TO THE CSU
TO COLLECT ON PAST DUE DEBTS.
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE TOTAL
PROHIBITION ON TAX OFFSET BEING
REMOVED, WE ARE STILL CONCERNED
WITH THE TWO YEAR DELAY. THIS
METHOD OF COLLECTION DOESN'T
HURT YOUR CREDIT SCORE, AND IT
PROVIDES $320,000 ON AVERAGE PER
CAMPUS PER YEAR. THAT'S OVER $7
MILLION SYSTEMWIDE ANNUALLY. WE
ALSO HOPE TO SEE THE PROHIBITION
ON DIPLOMA WITHHOLDING REMOVED.
I DO UNDERSTAND THIS IS BEING
CONSIDERED AS A POSSIBILITY. I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THE
DIPLOMA DOES NOT EQUAL THE
DEGREE THE STUDENTS COMPLETION
OF THEIR DEGREE IS COMMUNICATED
ON THEIR TRANSCRIPT, WHICH WE
CANNOT WITHHOLD, BUT THIS IS THE
LAST INTERNAL MECHANISM THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE TO US TO
INCENTIVIZE A STUDENT TO PAY A
PAST DUE DEBT, SINCE WE CAN'T
PLACE A HOLD ON THEIR CLASS
REGISTRATION THE NEXT SEMESTER
AS THEY ARE GRADUATING. ON
AVERAGE, OUR CAMPUSES PLACED A
HOLD ON 316 DIPLOMAS AT THE END
OF THIS CURRENT ACADEMIC YEAR.
WHILE WE INITIALLY ASKED FOR A
90 DAY WAITING PERIOD ON SENDING
DEBTS TO THIRD PARTY COLLECTION
RATHER THAN THE 180 DAYS IN THE
BILL, WE HAVE SINCE OFFERED THE
IDEA OF 120 DAYS WAITING PERIOD
AS A COMPROMISE. LASTLY, WHILE
WE UNDERSTAND THE INTENTION OF
THE ONE TIME EXEMPTION FOR
STUDENTS TO REENROLL OR REGISTER
FOR CLASSES, WHILE HOLDING A
PAST DUE DEBT, WE DO CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONCERNS WITH OUR ABILITY
TO ADMINISTER THIS. WE HAD
INSTEAD OFFERED THE IDEA THAT
ALL STUDENTS WITH A PAST DUE
DEBT BE OFFERED THE OPTION OF A
PAYMENT PLAN, WHICH IS A COMMON
PRACTICE OF OUR UNIVERSITY. I
ASSUME YOU'RE GOING TO ASK THIS
FOR A NO VOTE, AND WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE COMMUNICATION
METHODS IN THE BILL. HOPEFULLY
WE CAN GET TO A GOOD PLACE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS HÌNH AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA,
REPRESENTING THE STATE'S HUNDRED
AND 16 COMMUNITY COLLEGES. I
WANT TO START OFF BY ALSO
THANKING THE AUTHOR, THE STAFF
OF THE COMMITTEE AND ALSO THE
AUTHOR, STAFF FOR WORKING REALLY
CLOSELY WITH US AND MAKING SURE
A LOT OF OUR CONCERNS, ARE
HEARD. THE ONE TIME EXEMPTION IN
AB 1160 WILL BE INCREDIBLY HARD
FOR CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO IMPLEMENT, AS OPEN
ACCESS INSTITUTIONS. ANYONE CAN
LOG IN TO CÁC APPLY. COM RIGHT
NOW, ENROLL IN COURSES AND
BECOME A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT. DUE TO THE UNIQUE
NATURE OF OUR SYSTEM, IT IS
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO TRACK
ALL 2 MILLION COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WHO MAY BE ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE AN EXEMPTION AND ALSO
MAKE SURE THAT EACH STUDENT IS
ONLY USING THE ONE TIME
EXEMPTION ONCE DUE TO THE CLOSE
PROXIMITY OF OUR COLLEGES, THERE
IS NOTHING IN THIS BILL THAT
WOULD PREVENT A STUDENT FROM
USING A ONE TIME EXEMPTION AT
ONE INSTITUTION, DRIVING TEN
MINUTES TO ANOTHER INSTITUTION,
AND ALSO USING ANOTHER ONE TIME
EXEMPTION. THIS CREATES A PRIME
ENVIRONMENT FOR BAD ACTORS TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS VERY
WELL-INTENTIONED BILL, AND ALSO
IN THE ERA OF ONLINE LEARNING
AND FRAUDULENT STUDENTS, THIS
JUST INCREASES THE RISK OF BAD
ACTORS. IT WOULD TAKE
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE RESOURCES TO
EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENT THE ONE
TIME EXEMPTION, AND ENSURE THAT
COLLEGES HAVE THE CORRECT
TRACKING PATIENT TRACKING
SYSTEMS IN PLACE. CURRENTLY,
EACH COMMUNITY COLLEGE DOES
THINGS VERY DIFFERENTLY. THERE
ARE 73 DISTRICTS AND EACH
COLLEGE HAS THEIR OWN SYSTEM,
THEIR OWN STUDENT INFORMATION
SYSTEM. SO THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THEM TO REVAMP THEIR
STUDENT INFORMATION SYSTEM TO
CONSIDER THIS NEW EXEMPTION. AND
AS THE LOWEST FUNDED SEGMENT OF
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION, WE
SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO THAT, LASTLY, WE REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT EXTENDING THE
TIMELINE FOR COLLEGES TO REGAIN
FUNDS FROM THE TAX OFFSET
PROGRAM, FOR THOSE REASONS, WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. BUT
AGAIN, WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUE AT THE CSU
THAT WE ARE VERY, VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE
CONVERSATION. SO FAR AND LOOK
FORWARD TO FUTURE CONVERSATIONS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OTHERS WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GIVE US YOUR NAME,
YOUR AFFILIATION, YOUR POSITION.
JESSICA DUONG WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NICK ROMO
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. MISS SHAW,
ON BEHALF OF LOMA LINDA
UNIVERSITY HEALTH IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING,
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS. SENATOR
LAIRD? EXCUSE ME A QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR. AND I KNOW THAT YOU
TOOK, AN AMENDMENT ALREADY IN
REGARD TO THE HIGHER EDUCATION
FEEDBACK ABOUT, THE COLLECTING
INFORMATION AND A SPECIFIC
REPORT, AND THEY ALL SORT OF
SAID CONVERSATIONS ARE
CONTINUING. DO YOU SEE A PLACE
TO GO HERE? DO YOU THINK THAT
YOU CAN WORK TO SATISFY SOME OF
THEIR CONCERNS? I AM HOPEFUL
THAT I CAN SATISFY SOME OF THEIR
CONCERNS ALREADY WE'VE SATISFIED
A LOT OF THEIR CONCERNS. I'M
HOPING THAT WE CAN GET TO A
PLACE WHERE WE SATISFY ALL OF
THEIR CONCERNS, BUT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING HARD ON THIS BILL FROM
THE ASSEMBLY SIDE. WE'VE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS AND EVEN HERE ON THE
SENATE SIDE, WE'VE TAKEN
NUMEROUS AMENDMENTS AS WELL. AND
WE HAVE AN OPEN DOOR POLICY IN
MY OFFICE AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS. OKAY
BECAUSE WE'RE NEAR THE END HERE,
YOU KNOW, AND IT REALLY IS ABOUT
SEEING IF THERE'S ANY PLACE TO
GO AT THIS TIME. I'M WILLING TO
MOVE THE BILL AND HOPE THAT
THOSE CONVERSATIONS CONTINUE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
SENATOR LAIRD. OTHER QUESTIONS?
YES, SENATOR YELLOW. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR, TWO QUESTIONS WITH
REGARD TO CSU. DID I HEAR YOU
SAY THAT IN A YEAR THERE WERE
360 DIPLOMAS THAT WERE HELD. AS
A RESULT OF THAT, 316, 316, 316,
SIR, AT AT THE POINT OF TIME OF
I BELIEVE JUNE. SO AT ONE CAMPUS
AND HOW MANY TOTAL GRADUATES
WOULD THERE HAVE BEEN AT THAT
POINT IN TIME, UNFORTUNATELY,
I'M NOT SURE, SIR. OFF THE TOP
OF MY HEAD, IT WAS AN AVERAGE
TAKEN FROM ALL OF THE RESPONSES.
AND TO BE CLEAR, THE DIPLOMA
COULD STILL BE GRANTED LATER ON
IF THOSE 316 THAT WERE INITIALLY
HELD, IF THE DEBT WERE PAID, OR
WHEN THE DEBT IS PAID. RIGHT,
I'M JUST THINKING THAT SOUNDS
LIKE A RATHER SMALL NUMBER,
GIVEN WHAT I SUSPECT ARE THE
NUMBER OF DIPLOMAS OTHERWISE.
AND DO I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT,
EVEN IF THE DEBT ISN'T PAID, BUT
THE STUDENT HAS EXECUTED A
PAYMENT AGREEMENT THAT IS
CURRENT AT THAT TIME, THAT THE
DIPLOMA WOULD NOT BE HELD. Þ.
CORRECT, SIR. SO PAYMENT PLANS
FOR US WOULD NOT BE PAST DUE.
INSTITUTIONAL DEBT WOULD BE DEBT
. YOU'RE CURRENTLY WORKING
TOWARD PAYING AND HAVE AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE SCHOOL. SO
THERE WOULD NOT BE WITHHOLDING.
SO A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR WITH
THAT OPTION KNOWN, IF A STUDENT
REFUSED TO TALK TO THE
UNIVERSITY ABOUT A REPAYMENT
PLAN IN ORDER TO RECEIVE THE
DIPLOMA, I GUESS I'M CONFUSED
ABOUT THAT. IT'S ALMOST LIKE YOU
WOULD BE ENCOURAGING THE STUDENT
TO IGNORE THE DEBT. BASED UPON
THE ALLOWANCE OF THIS BILL,
ACTUALLY, WE'RE ENCOURAGING THE
STUDENTS TO PAY THEIR DEBT.
WE'RE ALSO ASKING THE COLLEGES
TO WORK WITH STUDENTS IN ORDER
TO ALLOW THEM TO PAY THE DEBT.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF MY WITNESSES
WANT TO ELABORATE. YEAH. NO,
THAT'S THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF THIS BILL.
IT'S ACTUALLY INCENTIVIZED FOR
STUDENTS TO RE TO ENROLL IN A
PAYMENT PLAN SO THAT THEY CAN
GET RIGHT ON TRACK WITH THEIR
STUDENT DEBT AND ACTUALLY BE
ABLE TO GET THEIR DIPLOMA. THE
RATIONALE BEHIND TRYING TO
ELIMINATE THE PROHIBITION OR TO
ELIMINATE THE USE OF DIPLOMA
HOLDS IS ACTUALLY BECAUSE IT IT
STANDS IN THE WAY OF A STUDENT
ACTUALLY BEING ABLE TO GET
FINANCIALLY STABLE, GETTING INTO
A JOB, OR BEGINNING THEIR CAREER
TO ACTUALLY REPAY THAT, THAT
DEBT ON THE BACK END. I
PERFECTLY UNDERSTAND THAT. BUT
IF, YOUR YOUR DISALLOWING THE,
UNIVERSITY FROM HOLDING THE
DIPLOMA IN THE ABSENCE OF JUST
EXECUTING AN AGREEMENT TO PAY
THE DEBT. SO I GUESS I'M A
LITTLE CONFUSED ABOUT THAT.
YEAH. THE STUDENT, ENCOURAGEMENT
OR OTHERWISE, THE STUDENT
DOESN'T PAY THE DEBT, DOESN'T
ENTER INTO AN AGREEMENT TO PAY
THE DEBT. IF THIS BILL PASSES,
THEY CAN'T HOLD THE DEGREE, BUT
THEY WOULD STILL HAVE TWO OTHER
VERY VIABLE OPPORTUNITIES TO
COLLECT ON THE DEBT. AFTER 180
DAYS, THEY CAN SUBJECT A
STUDENT. I'M JUST I'M CONFUSED
AS TO WHY, GIVEN ALL THE STUDENT
, IF THE STUDENT DOESN'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO PAY THE DEBT,
BUT, REALIZES THAT THAT GOING TO
THE UNIVERSITY AND SAYING, I
CAN'T PAY THE DEBT, WHAT CAN WE
DO ABOUT THIS? AND THE
UNIVERSITY WORKS OUT AN
AGREEMENT FOR THEM TO PAY. THEY
GET THE DIPLOMA. IF THEY DON'T
DO THAT, THEY GET THE DIPLOMA.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO ME HOW THAT
MAKES SENSE? I MEAN, THE ONE
THING I WOULD ADD IS IN
PRACTICE, YOUR PARDON, I SING,
THE ONE THING I WOULD ADD IS
THAT IN PRACTICE, THINGS DON'T
GO AS SMOOTHLY IN THE
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN
UNIVERSITY FINANCIAL AID OFFICES
AND UNIVERSITY BUSINESS OFFICES.
I THINK YOU'VE HEARD WE'VE HEARD
MORE, PERHAPS, THAN YOU OVER THE
COURSE OF THIS BILL THAT SCHOOLS
OFTEN DON'T KNOW QUITE WHAT
THEY'RE DOING TO COLLECT THESE
DEBTS. AND THE SEAMLESSNESS OF A
PAYMENT PLAN JUST BEING OFFERED
TO A STUDENT IS NOT ACTUALLY HOW
IT WORKS IN PRACTICE, I CAN TELL
YOU, BECAUSE I CHAIR THE
FINANCIAL AID COMMITTEE OF OUR
ACADEMIC SENATE AT UC MERCED,
AND I, I KNOW IT DOES NOT GO
THAT SMOOTHLY, SO WHAT IT'S
DOING, IT'S PUTTING THE IMPETUS
ON THE INSTITUTION TO REACH OUT
TO THE STUDENT TO PROVIDE A
PAYMENT PLAN TO PAY OFF THE
DEBT, AND IN THE MEANTIME, NOT
HOLDING UP THE STUDENT'S ABILITY
TO IMPROVE THEIR ECONOMIC
SITUATION BY RECEIVING THEIR
DIPLOMA. I THINK THAT'S THE BEST
THAT WE CAN SPEAK TO YOUR
CONCERNS. BUT IN IN RESPONSE TO
THE NEARLY YEAR AND A HALF OF
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
WITH THE SEGMENTS, THEY HAVE
MADE A VERY GOOD POINT ABOUT
THAT BEING A VERY LAST TOOL, A
TOOL OF LAST RESORT FOR THEM. IN
TERMS. LET ME JUST ASK, SENATOR,
DID YOU WANT FURTHER RESPONSE TO
YOUR QUESTION? NO, I THINK
THAT'S ENOUGH. I JUST ASK THE
CSU WITNESS TO RESPOND TO THE
COMMENT ABOUT MAYBE THE PROCESS
NOT BEING SO EASY. I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND, AND
I PERSONALLY CAN'T SPEAK TO THE
PROCESSES AT THAT CAMPUS OR AT
THE UC. I CAN TELL YOU THAT AT
THE CSU, WHEN A DEBT BECOMES
PAST DUE, SO DEADLINE IS PAST.
WE'VE ALREADY COMMUNICATED WITH
THE STUDENT THAT THIS IS THE
DEADLINE. THIS AMOUNT IS DUE.
WE'VE NOW PASSED THAT WE REQUIRE
ALL CAMPUSES TO DO AT LEAST
THREE OUTREACHES, AND THEY HAVE
TO BE DIFFERENT METHODS PHONE,
TEXT, EMAIL, SNAIL MAIL TO GET
THE STUDENT'S ATTENTION. MOST OF
OUR CAMPUSES ELECT TO DO FIVE
INSTEAD OF THREE OUTREACHES AT
THAT POINT, WHEN WE HAVE NOT
HEARD BACK, NO ONE HAS REACHED
OUT AND SAID, YES, I WOULD LIKE
TO COME TALK TO YOU ABOUT A
PAYMENT PLAN OR YES, I'LL COME
IN WITH A CHECK TO PAY THAT $50.
WE THEN ESCALATE TO THE EXTERNAL
METHODS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
US. OKAY. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
SENATOR ROTH, I'M JUST CURIOUS.
MAYBE YOU TOLD ME THIS. OF THE
316 DIPLOMAS THAT WERE WITHHELD,
WHAT WAS THE AVERAGE DEBT OWED
BY THE STUDENT TO THE CSU? IT'S
SUCH A GOOD QUESTION, SIR. AND I
WISH I KNEW THAT WAS THE HARDEST
DATA POINT FOR US TO GATHER. AND
MY FOLKS LET ME KNOW THAT WE ARE
NOT ABLE TO GET THAT LEVEL OF
DATA THAT I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE,
JUST BECAUSE OF HOW OUR SYSTEM
IS SET UP AND HOW IT'S THE POINT
IN TIME THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
CAPTURE THE INFORMATION. SO I
WISH I KNEW AND IF I IF I GET
THAT INFORMATION, I'LL SHARE IT
WITH YOUR STAFF. WELL WHAT'S
WHAT'S IN THAT PARTICULAR GROUP
THEN? WHAT'S THE TOTAL DEBT OWED
TO THE CSU? TOTAL DEBT OWED FOR
THE 316 PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T GET
THEIR DIPLOMAS. I WISH I KNEW.
I'M SORRY. SORRY, I DON'T HAVE
THAT SPECIFICALLY FOR DIPLOMAS.
AS ONE REFERENCE POINT, THE
AVERAGE IS $4.5 MILLION PER
CAMPUS OF DEBT THAT IS ACCRUED
IN ONE ACADEMIC YEAR. WELL, YOU
ANYBODY WHO DOES DEBT, DEBT
COLLECTION, YOU MUST HAVE A LIST
OF PEOPLE THAT OWE YOU MONEY IN
TERMS OF STUDENTS, RIGHT? I
THINK I UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION.
YES, WE DO HAVE PEOPLE WORKING
ON THIS. THE LEVEL OF DATA I WAS
ABLE TO GET DID NOT INCLUDE THE
AMOUNTS TOTAL. SPECIFICALLY FOR
THE DIPLOMA HOLD. I CAN GO BACK
AND ASK FOR MORE INFORMATION ON
THAT SPECIFIC POINT, RIGHT? I
MEAN, I'M JUST SORT OF CURIOUS
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, IF WE'RE
HOLDING A DIPLOMA FOR SOMEBODY
WHO'S BEEN ONE OF YOUR CUSTOMERS
FOR FOUR YEARS AND LET'S JUST
SAY THEY'VE PAID TUITION AND
WHATEVER ELSE THEY HAVE TO PAY
THAT YOU'RE ASSESSING, FOR THREE
AND A HALF OF THE YEARS, AND
THEN THEY FALL OFF THE WAGON AND
THEY OWE $1,500 TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM, AND WE'RE HOLDING A
DIPLOMA WHETHER OR NOT THEY
EXECUTE A PAYMENT PLAN. YOU
KNOW, WE DON'T KNOW THE
CIRCUMSTANCE, IT SEEMS A LITTLE
EXTREME, SO. BUT ON THE OTHER
HAND, IF THEY NEVER PAID THE
TUITION AFTER THE FIRST SEMESTER
OR QUARTER, AND YOU KEPT THEM ON
THE ROLLS AND GAVE THEM A RIDE
DOWN TO THE END OF THE ROAD,
MAYBE THAT WOULD BE DIFFERENT.
MIGHT HAVE A DIFFERENT OPINION
ON IT. SO I'M JUST SORT OF
CURIOUS. I WOULD LIKE THE
INFORMATION, BUT THROUGH THE
CHAIR WHEN YOU GET IT WOULD BE
JUST FINE. ABSOLUTELY I LOOK
THANK YOU, THANK YOU MR. THANK
YOU. SENATOR ROTH. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? IS THERE
A MOTION NØ SENATOR LAIRD HAS
MOVED THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, ONE COMMENT IS THAT, IN
TERMS OF, FOR EXAMPLE, JOBS,
TYPICALLY IT IS THE, TRANSCRIPT
OR IT IS SOME INDICATION OF
GRADUATION THAT IS THE CRITICAL
ELEMENT. IS THAT RIGHT? AND SO
YOU DON'T WITHHOLD THAT. SO IF
SOMEONE APPLIES FOR A JOB AND
THEY SAY, I'VE GRADUATED FROM
XYZ SCHOOL, THEN YOU WILL
CONFIRM THAT THEY'RE A GRADUATE
OF THE SCHOOL. YOU JUST WON'T
GIVE THEM THE PIECE OF PAPER
100% CORRECT. ALL RIGHT. AND I
WOULD ASK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PACHECO I JUST TO ME IT DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE THAT WE OWE THAT PIECE
OF PAPER TO DISPLAY ON ONE'S
WALL. WE MAY OWE THEM THE
ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT THEY'VE
GRADUATED. AND IF THAT DIPLOMA,
THAT PIECE OF PAPER THAT HANGS
ON ONE'S WALL, IS THE INCENTIVE
TO PAY OFF THEIR DEBT, MAYBE
THAT'S NOT SUCH A BAD IDEA FOR
YOU TO CONSIDER, AS THIS BILL
MOVES TO APPROPRIATIONS. SO, ALL
RIGHT, HAVING SAID THAT, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES.
RESPECTFULLY. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR. AYE VOTE. ALRIGHTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER 21, AB
1160. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG Ã
UMBERG. AYE. WILK ALLEN. ASHBY.
CABALLERO DURAZZO. LAIRD. LAIRD.
AYE MILO. ROTH ROTH. AYE. STERN
WAHAB. 3 TO 0 THREE ZERO. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALANIZ. SO FIRST OFF, LET ME
CONGRATULATE YOU ON YOUR
INGENUITY. HOW DID YOU ARRANGE A
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS HERE SO YOU
COULD MOVE FROM, SAY, 10 P.M.
TO, WHATEVER TIME IT IS NOW?
1240. SO THAT WAS QUITE. I MADE
SURE THE CATERERS STAYED THERE
LONGER. THEY'RE GOOD FOR YOU ALL
RIGHT, SO HERE'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO. IS SOME OF THEM
ARE. ALANIZ IS HERE. HE'S GOING
TO PRESENT HIS BILL. WE WILL
TAKE WHATEVER ACTION WE CAN ON
ON THAT BILL. AND THEN IF
THERE'S ANOTHER AUTHOR THAT
APPEARS, WE WILL CONTINUE OUR
OPERATION. OTHERWISE WE WILL WE
WILL TAKE A BREAK. SO WE'LL BE
DONE REAL QUICK. ALL RIGHT,
WELL, THANK YOU AGAIN. I WANT TO
THANK YOU GUYS AND YOUR STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH ME IN MY
OFFICE. I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS TODAY. MY
OFFICE HAS BEEN WORKING HARD TO
TRY TO BALANCE THE OPPOSITIONS
SO THAT FOLKS WATCHING ARE
CLEAR. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
67, AB 3080, AB 3080. YES THANK
YOU, WE'VE TRIED IN GOOD FAITH
TO WORK WITH BOTH PRIMARY
OPPOSITION AND THE INITIAL
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL TO FIND A
PATH FORWARD AFTER DIFFICULT
PATH AND A LONG ROAD. I AM
PLEASED TO REPORT THIS COMMITTEE
TO THIS COMMITTEE THAT OUR
PRIMARY OPPOSITION, THE FREE
SPEECH COALITION, HAS REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. AB
38 ESTABLISHES A NEW FRAMEWORK
AND STANDARD OF ACCOUNTABILITY
AND WEBSITES, ENSURING THAT THEY
ADOPT ADDITIONAL METHODS OF
VERIFYING THE AGE OF THE USERS.
I HAVE SAID ON THE RECORD THAT I
WOULD CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
PRIVACY CONCERNS IN THE SENATE.
I BELIEVE THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN
WILL BE MORE WILL BE MORE THAN
ACCOMPLISH THOSE GOALS. I
UNDERSTAND FROM THE BEGINNING
THAT DESPITE SIMILAR
LEGISLATIONS BEING PASSED IN
OTHER STATES, CALIFORNIA WOULD
NEED ITS OWN MODEL. I HAVE
WORKED TO BUILD CONSENSUS ON
THIS LEGISLATION. WHAT IS BEFORE
YOU TODAY REFLECTS THE HARD WORK
OF MY TEAM. MULTIPLE COMMITTEES
IN BOTH HOUSES AND SERIOUS
DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN ALL. THERE
HAVE BEEN MULTIPLE ATTEMPTS TO
PASS SIMILAR LEGISLATIONS OVER
THE YEARS. THIS IS THE FIRST
PROPOSAL THAT HAS WON BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS A
REAL CHANCE TO REACH THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK. I BELIEVE THIS
BILL REPRESENTS A POSITIVE STEP
FORWARD AND WILL BRING
COMPREHENSIVE AND NEEDED
PROTECTIONS FOR KIDS. AND AT THE
END OF THE DAY, THAT IS WHAT IS
MOST IMPORTANT FOR US HERE,
WHICH IS PROTECTING OUR KIDS. I
HAVE MY LEDGER HERE IN CASE WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. OTHER THAN
THAT, I HAVE NO WITNESSES FOR
YOU TO TESTIFY. AN EXCELLENT
WITNESS. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF FILE
NUMBER 67, AB 3080. PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE, SEEING
NO WITNESSES. APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. NOW, LET'S TURN TO
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 3080, PLEASE APPROACH. YOU
MAY EITHER COME TO THE TABLE OR
USE THE MICROPHONE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. CHAIR UMBERG AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS GREG GONZALEZ AND I AM
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL FOR THE
FOUNDATION FOR INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS
AND EXPRESSION, ALSO KNOWN AS
FIRE. FIRE IS A NONPARTISAN
NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO
PROTECTING FREE SPEECH RIGHTS
FOR ALL AMERICANS BASED ON
WELL-ESTABLISHED SUPREME COURT
PRECEDENT, AB 3080 WILL VIOLATE
THE FIRST AMENDMENT AND WILL NOT
SURVIVE JUDICIAL REVIEW. THE
SUPREME COURT HAS ALREADY
CONSIDERED WHETHER AGE
VERIFICATION PROVISIONS, LIKE
THOSE IN AB 3080, CAN SURVIVE
STRICT SCRUTINY IN ASHCROFT
VERSUS ACLU, THE SUPREME COURT
REVIEWED THE CHILD ONLINE
PROTECTION ACT, A LAW THAT
SIMILARLY REQUIRED AGE
VERIFICATION OF USERS TO ACCESS
ADULT CONTENT ONLINE. AFTER
LOWER COURTS BLOCKED THE
LEGISLATION, THE SUPREME COURT
UPHELD THE INJUNCTION ON GROUNDS
THAT THE GOVERNMENT WAS UNLIKELY
TO BE ABLE TO PROVE THAT THE LAW
COULD PASS CONSTITUTIONAL
MUSTER. SPECIFICALLY, THE COURT
FOUND IT UNLIKELY THAT AGE
VERIFICATION IS, QUOTE, THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE MEANS AMONG
AVAILABLE EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVES
. END QUOTE, TO MEET CONGRESS'S
GOAL OF PREVENTING MINORS FROM
ACCESSING THIS CONTENT, THIS
PRECEDENT WOULD DOOM THE AGE
VERIFICATION PROVISION OF AB
3080 WHEN IT FACES JUDICIAL
SCRUTINY. IN FACT, JUST ON
FRIDAY, A FEDERAL JUDGE HALTED
INDIANA'S AGE VERIFICATION LAW
BECAUSE OF THE ASHCROFT
DECISION. THE LEGAL PRECEDENT,
THE LEGAL AND PRUDENTIAL
PROBLEMS WITH AB 3080 ARE NOT
FIXED BY THE AMENDMENT THAT
ALLOWS WEBSITES TO COMPLY WITH
C¢M, COMPLY BY INCLUDING
METADATA OR RESPONSE HEADERS
THAT IDENTIFY THE WEBSITES AS
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT. A TRULY
VOLUNTARY RATING SYSTEM
UNDERTAKEN BY PRIVATE ACTORS
DOES NOT POSE A CONSTITUTIONAL
CONCERN, BUT WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
TIES A RAIN OR TAGGING SYSTEM TO
A GOVERNMENT MANDATED
REQUIREMENT, THE RATINGS ARE NO
LONGER VOLUNTARY. AS SUCH, THE
TAGGING SYSTEM PROPOSED HERE
WOULD FAIL. FIRST AMENDMENT
SCRUTINY. FIRE URGES YOU TO
STAND UP FOR FREE SPEECH AND
REJECT AB 3080. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS CHAIR. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
JOHN LIU HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION.
WE OPPOSE AB 3080, WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE BUSINESSES TO COLLECT
INFORMATION TO VERIFY THE AGE OF
ANYONE VISITING A WEBSITE DEEMED
TO OFFER SEXUALLY EXPLICIT
CONTENT. WE SHARE THE FIRST
AMENDMENT CONCERNS OF MANY
GROUPS, INCLUDING FIRE, HAVE
WITH THE BILL ADRIN VACATION
HARMS EVERYONE'S ABILITY TO
ACCESS CONTENT ONLINE AND IS
ESPECIALLY LIKELY TO RESTRICT
ACCESS TO LEGITIMATE CONTENT
LIKE LGBTQ PLUS EDUCATION
INFORMATION, REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
INFORMATION, AND SEXUAL
EDUCATION. AT THEIR CORE, AGE
VERIFICATION REGIMES ARE
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS THAT
THREATEN EVERYONE'S ABILITY.
EVERYONE'S PRIVACY ONLINE. FOR
THESE LAWS TO WORK, THEY DON'T
ONLY CONFIRM THE AGES OF YOUNG
PEOPLE, THEY MUST CONFIRM THE
AGES OF ALL WEBSITE VISITORS.
THE PASSAGE OF AB 3080 WOULD
LIKELY REQUIRE ADULTS TO SUBMIT
GOVERNMENT ISSUED IDS TO ATTEMPT
TO DETERMINE THEIR AGE, WHICH
CREATES A POTENTIALLY LASTING
RECORD OF NOT ONLY ONE'S VISIT
TO A WEBSITE, BUT THEIR ID AS
WELL. THE MORE DATA COLLECTED,
THE GREATER THE CHANCE SUCH DATA
GETS INTO THE HANDS OF BAD
ACTORS ARE EXPOSED IN A DATA
BREACH OR IS DEMANDED IN A
SUBPOENA. JUST LAST WEEK, IT WAS
FOUND THAT A COMPANY THAT
VERIFIES IDENTITIES FOR TIKTOK,
UBER AND ACTS EXPOSED A SET OF
ADMINISTRATIVE CREDENTIALS
ONLINE FOR OVER A YEAR, ALLOWING
ANYONE WHO USED THESE
CREDENTIALS TO HAVE SEEN NOT
JUST SOMEONE'S NAME, DATE OF
BIRTH AND NATIONALITY, BUT EVEN
DOWNLOAD A PICTURE OF THE VERY
DOCUMENT USED IN THE
VERIFICATION. LASTLY THESE
SYSTEMS WILL NOT WORK AS
INTENDED. THE FRENCH EQUIVALENT
OF THE FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION
FOUND THAT THESE REGIMES ONLY
DRIVE TRAFFIC AWAY FROM
REGULATED SITES INTO UNREGULATED
AND MORE DANGEROUS ONLINE
SPACES. US BASED RESEARCH IS
BEGINNING TO FIND THE SAME. FOR
ALL THESE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO VOTE NO ON AB 30 TODAY. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 3080, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. NAME.
AFFILIATION. POSITION. YES. HI
TRACY ROSENBERG, ON BEHALF OF
OAKLAND PRIVACY, WE ARE STILL IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN PRINT.
WE APPRECIATE THE OUTREACH FROM
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE, AND WE WILL
TAKE A LOOK AT THE MOST RECENT
SET OF CHANGES. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. CYNTHIA VALENCIA WITH THE
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, DANNY
KENDALL KAISER, ON BEHALF OF THE
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE,
TRANS YOUTH LIBERATION
TRANSGENDER LAW CENTER AND THE
NATIONAL CENTER ON LESBIAN
RIGHTS AND OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SENATOR NIHILO
MOVES THE BILL. ALL RIGHT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALANIS, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER 67, AB 3080.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. UMBERG Ã UMBERG. AYE
WILK ALLEN ASHBY. CABALLERO.
DURAZO LAIRD I. LAIRD I NILO.
NILO I. ROTH. ROTH I STERN. FOUR
TO 0 OR 0. PUT THAT ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. SO REMEMBER, BERMAN,
I THINK I SAW YOU HERE. OKAY SO
REMEMBER BERMAN, FILE NUMBER 60,
AB 2655. THANK YOU, SENATOR
HAMBURG AND SENATOR, I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR HIS THOROUGH
ANALYSIS AND FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO WORK WITH MY OFFICE WHILE
JUGGLING THE OVERWHELMING
WORKLOAD. FOR THIS HEARING. I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS. FIVE
YEARS AGO, I AUTHORED THE FIRST
ELECTION DEEPFAKE BILL IN THE
NATION. JUST A FEW SHORT YEARS
LATER, THE TECHNOLOGY IS BETTER,
CHEAPER, AND MORE WIDELY
ACCESSIBLE, AND WE'RE SEEING
DEEPFAKES USE TO UNDERMINE
ELECTIONS ACROSS THE GLOBE AND
HERE IN AMERICA THIS PAST MONTH.
ACTUALLY, A STUDY FROM GOOGLE'S
DEEPMIND AI DIVISION CONFIRMED
OUR FEAR, FINDING THAT AI
GENERATED DEEPFAKES THAT
IMPERSONATE POLITICIANS AND
CELEBRITIES ARE THE MOST POPULAR
WAYS TO MISUSE AI. THE REPORT
SPECIFICALLY FOUND USERS DEPLOY
A RANGE OF TACTICS TO DISTORT
THE PUBLIC'S PERCEPTION OF
POLITICAL REALITIES. THAT'S WHY
I'M AUTHORING AB 2655 TO PROTECT
ELECTION INTEGRITY BY REQUIRING
LARGE ONLINE PLATFORMS TO, FOR A
LIMITED TIME, RESTRICT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF MATERIALLY
DECEPTIVE CONTENT INTENDED TO
SWAY VOTERS OR UNDERMINE
CONFIDENCE IN ELECTIONS FOR LESS
HARMFUL, YET STILL MATERIALLY
DECEPTIVE CONTENT. THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE PLATFORMS TO
LABEL IT AS ELECTION
DISINFORMATION. I'VE GOT A
COUPLE OTHER COMMENTS, BUT I'LL
SAVE THEM FOR LATER.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AND WITH ME TODAY ARE TWO
FANTASTIC WITNESSES ON BEHALF OF
THE SPONSOR CITED, WHO CAN GO
INTO A LITTLE MORE DETAIL. ALL
RIGHT. ON THE BILL, FIRST,
FANTASTIC WITNESS. GO AHEAD.
OOH, THAT'S TOUGH TO LIVE UP TO
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M LAURA
GERSHENSON WITH CITED THE
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE FOR
TECHNOLOGY AND DEMOCRACY, A
PROJECT OF CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE. AB 2655 SEEKS TO PROTECT
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS
FROM THE WORST OF THE WORST
DEEPFAKES MEANT TO DEFRAUD OUR
ELECTORATE AND UNDERMINE FAITH
IN OUR DEMOCRACY. WE BELIEVE
THAT AB 2655 STRIKES THE RIGHT
BALANCE BY BANNING, FOR A
STRICTLY LIMITED TIME AROUND THE
ELECTIONS, THE ONLINE SPREAD OF
THE WORST DEEPFAKES INTENDED TO
DECEIVE VOTERS AND INFLUENCE
ELECTIONS. VIDEOS, IMAGES AND
AUDIOS OF CANDIDATES, ELECTION
OFFICIALS AND ELECTED OFFICIALS
DOING OR SAYING SOMETHING THEY
DIDN'T DO OR SAY THAT APPEAR
THAT APPEAR REAL AND THAT ARE
REASONABLY LIKELY TO CHANGE THE
ELECTION OUTCOMES OR FALSELY
UNDERMINE CONFIDENCE IN THE
ELECTION. THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
THAT OTHER FAKE ONLINE CONTENT
THAT ISN'T QUITE AS BAD IS
LABELED AGAIN, FOR A LIMITED
TIME AROUND, THE ELECTION. WHILE
THIS BILL CAN'T STOP ALL
ELECTION MISINFORMATION, IT WILL
HELP REMOVE SOME OF THE WORST
DEEPFAKES FROM THE ECOSYSTEM
CLOSE TO ELECTION TIMES WHEN
VOTERS ARE PAYING THE MOST
ATTENTION. PLEASE HELP US
PROTECT OUR DEMOCRACY. THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. NEXT.
FANTASTIC WITNESS. THANK YOU.
CHAIR UMBERG. IT'S AN HONOR TO
BE HERE WITH YOU TODAY. MY NAME
IS DAVID HARRIS, AND I'M A
SENIOR POLICY ADVISOR TO CITED.
I ALSO TEACH AT UC BERKELEY AT
THE HAAS SCHOOL OF BUSINESS
ABOUT AI ETHICS AND POLICY. AND
I'VE BEEN AN ADVISOR TO NUMEROUS
INTERNATIONAL BODIES. I'VE
ADVISED THE EUROPEAN UNION, THE
WHITE HOUSE, NATO, ALL ON AI
POLICY. I'M HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB 2655 BECAUSE IT
TAKES ACTION WHERE TECH
COMPANIES WILL NOT. I PREVIOUSLY
WORKED FOR CLOSE TO FIVE YEARS
AT FACEBOOK AND META, WHERE I
WAS A RESEARCH MANAGER ON THE
RESPONSIBLE AI TEAM AND ALSO ON
THE CIVIC INTEGRITY TEAM IN
THOSE COMPANIES, WE HAVE A
PROBLEM, WHICH IS THAT THE
COMPANIES ARE NOT WILLING TO DO
ANYTHING THAT IS NOT LEGALLY
REQUIRED OF THEM. WHERE DEEP
FAKES AND ELECTIONS AND AI ARE
CONCERNED. THIS IS DIFFICULT
BECAUSE WHAT IT MEANS IS THAT
WHEN CERTAIN COMPANIES STEP OUT
AND TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THESE PROBLEMS, THEY GET
PUNISHED. THEY GET PUNISHED BY
THEIR SHAREHOLDERS AND THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. AND THEY HAVE TO
LAY OFF THE WORKERS THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR DETECTING DEEP
FAKES AND GETTING RID OF THESE
KINDS OF EFFORTS AT ELECTION
INTERFERENCE. AN INTERESTING
THING THAT PERHAPS MAKES THE AI
INDUSTRY UNIQUE IS THAT MANY AI
CEOS HAVE THEMSELVES DEMANDED
MORE REGULATION OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE, AND THAT'S WHY
BILLS LIKE AB 2655, THAT PLACE
CLEAR RULES ABOUT WHAT AI CAN BE
USED FOR AND WHAT SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS CAN AND CANNOT
DISPLAY, AND DISTRIBUTE TO THEIR
USERS ARE NECESSARY. SO I'M HERE
TO CALL ON YOU TO GIVE THE TECH
COMPANY CEOS EXACTLY WHAT THEY
ARE ASKING FOR, WHICH IS BETTER
REGULATION OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE, WHERE OUR
DEMOCRACY IS CONCERNED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. NAME, AFFILIATION
AND POSITION. CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. BENJAMIN COHEN OF MOUNTAIN
VIEW IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE
ELSE APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE.
LET'S TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO FILE NUMBER 60
AB 2655, YOU MAY EITHER TAKE A
CHAIR OR COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
GO AHEAD. WHOEVER WOULD LIKE TO
GO FIRST OKAY. FIRST. FANTASTIC
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. OKAY
PERFECT, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS NAOMI PEDRONI,
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPUTER AND COMMUNICATIONS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB
2655, CTIA AND ITS MEMBERS TAKE
SERIOUSLY THE IMPACT DECEPTIVE
CONTENT MAY HAVE ON ELECTIONS.
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO IMPLEMENT TOOLS TO
BETTER DETECT AND LABEL AI
GENERATED CONTENT, BUT THE TOOLS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE ARE
NOT ALWAYS RELIABLE OR ACCURATE.
AND WHILE SUCH TECHNOLOGY IS
EVOLVING, SO ARE THE MEANS FOR
BAD ACTORS TO EVADE DETECTION.
WE APPRECIATE THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS AS WELL AS THOSE
REFERENCED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. HOWEVER, WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND ARE
SPECIFICALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL IMPACTS ON FREE
SPEECH, AN ISSUE THAT IS ALSO
THOROUGHLY OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS, PRESUMABLY UNDER AB
2655, THE INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
BEING SOUGHT WOULD RESULT IN THE
BLOCKING OR LABELING OF REPORTED
CONTENT. THIS WOULD BE
WEAPONIZED BY COMPETING PARTIES
THAT COULD SIMPLY DISAGREE WITH
THE CONTENT OR EACH OTHER. THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES THAT
THE BILL'S STANDARDS, QUOTE,
PLACE A BURDEN ON PLATFORMS TO
ESTABLISH FACTS POTENTIALLY WELL
OUTSIDE OF THEIR BOUNDS OF
KNOWING. INDEED, PLATFORMS ARE
NOT PRIVY TO THE INTENT AND
CONTEXT FOR WHICH A PIECE OF
CONTENT IS USED AND COULD
INADVERTENTLY, OVER BLOCK OR
OVER LABEL. THIS COULD RESULT IN
USER FRUSTRATION AND SUPPRESSION
OF POLITICAL SPEECH. POLITICAL
SPEECH WAS AT THE CORE OF WHY
OUR FIRST AMENDMENT WAS
ESTABLISHED. RESPONSIBILITY FOR
LABELING AI GENERATED ELECTION
CONTENT AND LIABILITY FOR
DECEPTIVE CONTENT SHOULD REST
WITH THE ENTITY THAT ORIGINALLY
PUTS FORTH SUCH MATERIAL.
ADDITIONALLY, WE HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
WHILE IT ESTABLISHES DEFINED
PERIODS SURROUNDING ELECTIONS.
AB 2655 DOES NOT SPECIFY WHICH
ELECTIONS AND WHERE. THIS COULD
RESULT IN PLATFORMS BEING
REQUIRED TO BLOCK CONTENT ALMOST
CONSTANTLY TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION OF OUR COMMENTS.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO
VOTE. ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NOT TO BE JUDGY. SECOND,
FANTASTIC WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. TRACY ROSENBERG,
OAKLAND PRIVACY, AB 2655 SETS UP
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES WHO WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT, HAVE NO
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW TRAINING, NO
TRAINING IN ELECTIONS LAW AS
JUDGE, JURY AND EXECUTIONER,
THEY'RE RELYING ON TWO PRETTY
IMPRECISE MEASURES PUBLIC
REPORTS FROM OTHER CANDIDATES OR
CHAOS ACTORS OR SCANNING TOOLS.
NEITHER WORKS. DEEPFAKE
DETECTION SERVICES HAVE BEEN
FOOLED INTO DECLARING IMAGES OF
KISSING ROBOTS AND GIANT
NEANDERTHALS. TO BE REAL, WHEN
THEY'RE NOT. THIS IS NOT WHAT
PEOPLE WANT. A 2023 POLL
REPORTED THAT 61% OF DEMOCRATS,
62% OF INDEPENDENTS AND AN EVEN
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF REPUBLICANS
DO NOT TRUST SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES TO MODERATE CONTENT ON
THEIR PLATFORMS FAIRLY. WE
BELIEVE THAT LABELING SYNTHETIC
CONTENT IS USEFUL AND IT HELPS
OUT VOTERS, BUT A BROAD
CENSORSHIP REGIME BY THE TITANS
OF TECH IS NOT THE WAY THAT WE
SHOULD GO. AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
NO VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION TO AB. 2655
2655. THANK YOU, YOUR HONOR.
WITH CAL CHAMBER ALSO OPPOSED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CHARGING
WITH THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BRIAN
MIRAMONTEZ, AMERICAN FEDERATION
OF STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES, APOLOGIES FOR BEING
OUT OF ORDER. WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
IN SUPPORT. OKAY. GOT IT.
CYNTHIA VALENCIA, LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN OPPOSITION
DUE TO FIRST AMENDMENT CONCERNS.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. I
APOLOGIZE ALSO ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUE AT TECHNET. OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
QUESTIONS BY SENATOR STERN.
YEAH, THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR.
I'M SURE THIS IS SOMEWHAT OF A
RELUCTANT EFFORT IN THAT WISH.
WE DIDN'T HAVE TO BE IN THIS
POSITION TO SORT OF PUSH THE
ENVELOPE HERE AND DO WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO, AND STEP IN. BUT OUR
DEMOCRACY IS TRULY AT RISK, MY
QUESTION IS, I DON'T I DON'T
TRUST THE SUPREME COURT ON THESE
ISSUES THESE DAYS. AND EITHER
FROM YOU OR THE EXPERTS, I WANT
TO SEE THIS IN LAW. I WANT TO
SEE THIS EXECUTED, BUT DOES DOES
SOME OF THAT, I FORGET THE NAME
OF THE CASES, BUT SOME OF THE
WORK IN APPELLATE COURTS, I
THINK IT'S IN SOME OF THE META
CASES ON FREE SPEECH, IS THAT IS
THERE IS THERE WAYS WE CAN
PREVENT AGAINST THAT SORT OF
FALLING INTO ANY TRAPS THAT
MIGHT OCCUR OUT OF SOME OF THAT
APPELLATE REVIEW, I THINK
PURSUANT TO A FLORIDA LAW, IF I
RECALL CORRECTLY, THE RECENT
CASES. YEAH, YEAH. LET ME JUST
SAY, AT A HIGH LEVEL, WE ARE
VERY EAGER TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO MAKE SURE IT'S AS
NARROWLY TAILORED AS POSSIBLE, I
THINK EVERYONE AGREES IT'S
ADDRESSING A COMPELLING
GOVERNMENT INTEREST. SO WE CHECK
THAT BOX, THERE'S ACTIVE
LITIGATION HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THE SUPREME COURT JUST,
SENT THOSE CASES BACK TO THOSE
APPELLATE COURTS, TO, TO BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T THINK THEY APPLIED
THE LAW CORRECTLY. BUT I'LL
DEFER TO MY WITNESSES WHO MIGHT
HAVE A LITTLE MORE DETAIL ON
THAT. THERE IS NOTHING IN THOSE
CASES THAT ACTUALLY WOULD CHANGE
THIS BILL. THOSE CASES ADDRESSED
FOR SPEECH. AND IN FACT, THERE
WAS ONE ISSUE ON FOR SPEECH THAT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED, COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSE WE TAKE THAT WOULD LIMIT
THAT FOR SPEECH. THAT'S THE ONLY
SIMILAR ISSUE. WHAT IT DID SAY
IS THAT THE COURT SHOULD
ACTUALLY CONSIDER HOW THESE
FIRST AMENDMENT CASES ARE
APPLIED AND NOT JUST LOOK AT THE
FACE, HOW THEY ARE APPLIED
FACIALLY. SO YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
THEM APPLIED TO THE FACTS.
REGARDLESS, IN ALL LIKELIHOOD,
THIS THIS BILL WOULD BE
LITIGATED BECAUSE IT'S A
QUESTION OF, YOU KNOW, HOW
NARROWLY TAILORED ARE YOU? WE
HAVE A COMPELLING STATE
INTEREST, WHICH IS PROTECTING
OUR DEMOCRACY. AND THEN IS THIS
NARROWLY TAILORED ENOUGH TO
SERVE THAT COMPELLING INTEREST?
IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE, AS MOST
OF THE TECH BILLS, THAT SOMEONE
CHALLENGES THEM. BUT THE POINT
IS TO ACTUALLY MAKE SOME GOOD
LAW. AND I DON'T KNOW THAT IT
NECESSARILY REACHES THE SUPREME
COURT. SOME CALIFORNIA CASES
REACH THE SUPREME COURT. MOST
DON'T. BUT I WHAT WE'VE DONE IS
TRY TO MAKE THE STRONGEST
POSSIBLE CASE UNDER THE FIRST
AMENDMENT AND UNDER SECTION 230
FOR THIS BILL TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND WE THINK WE'VE DONE THAT.
AND I WANT TO REITERATE FOR
EVERYBODY, MY OFFICE IS WIDE
OPEN FOR SUGGESTIONS FOR HOW TO
MAKE IT MORE NARROWLY TAILORED.
I HAD THAT CHAT WITH MY CHIEF
YESTERDAY. SO IF FOLKS HAVE ANY
IDEAS THAT DON'T UNDERMINE THE
BILL, THEN I'M VERY OPEN TO
HEARING THOSE. AND I WOULD SAY
NOT TO NOT TO, FORCE THIS WORK
ON OUR, ATTORNEY GENERAL. BUT, I
KNOW THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY BEING
CHALLENGED ON A COMPELLED
POLITICAL SPEECH CASE FOR A
CLIMATE DISCLOSURE LAW THAT THE
US CHAMBER AND THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER ARE CHALLENGING
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY, UNDER THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, TO REQUIRE
COMPANIES TO DISCLOSE THEIR
THEIR GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS,
AND CALLING THAT A SORT OF A
FORM OF COMPELLED POLITICAL
SPEECH, THIS IS A NEW AND VERY
IMPORTANT AREA OF LAW FOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO BE ABLE TO
DEFEND OUR INTERESTS, WHETHER
IT'S IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY OR THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTIONS. SO I THINK IT IS
GOING TO TAKE SOME SOME HEAVY
LIFTING WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. SO HOPEFULLY BEFORE
THIS HITS THE FLOOR TO JUST
GIVING IT THAT SCRUB AND GETTING
OURSELVES READY TO PREVAIL SO WE
CAN ACTUALLY GET TO AN
IMPLEMENTATION STAGE. AND I'M
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL. REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU JUST GOING DEEP
ON THIS, AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
GET THIS INTO LAW AND THROUGH
OUR COURT SYSTEM. I AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING YOU SAID. THANK YOU.
I THINK, SENATOR STERN, YOU JUST
MOVED THE BILL. YES I DID, YES
YOU DID. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHIEF. COUNSEL, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FILE ITEM NUMBER 60 A B
2655, THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS.
UMBERG UMBERG I WILK ALLEN ASHBY
. CABALLERO. DURAZZO. LAIRD
NILO. NILO. NÓ ROTH. STERN.
WAHAB ONE TO. I'M SORRY. STERN
STERN, I WAHAB. THAT'S 2 TO 1
WITH MEMBERS MISSING 32 TO 1.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL NEXT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL. TWO
MATTERS, AND I'M GOING TO TURN
OVER THE CHAIRMANSHIP HERE FOR A
MOMENT TO SENATOR STERN.
GOOD AFTERNOON. WELCOME THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. I HAVE TWO
MATTERS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. FIRST IS, IF IT'S OKAY,
I'LL GO. I'LL BEGIN WITH AB
3048. OKAY. THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
SENATORS, LET ME START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS LISTED
IN THE ANALYSIS. AND THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR THEIR HELP
AND PATIENCE. AB 3048 IS A
SIMPLE BILL. WE'RE ACTUALLY
WE'RE ACTUALLY. ARE YOU ON 3048
OKAY. AB 3048 IS A SIMPLE BILL.
IT'D BE 3048. MAKES IT EASIER
FOR CONSUMERS TO STATE THEIR
PRIVACY PREFERENCES FROM THE
START BY REQUIRING WEB BROWSERS
TO ALLOW A USER TO EXERCISE
THEIR OPT OUT RIGHTS AT ALL
BUSINESSES WITH WHICH THEY
INTERACT ONLINE IN A SINGLE STEP
. CURRENTLY, THREE BROWSER
COMPANIES ALREADY IMPLEMENT EASY
TO FIND OPT OUT PREFERENCES.
THEY ARE MOZILLA FIREFOX,
DUCKDUCKGO, AND BRAVE. THE OTHER
BROWSER COMPANIES REQUIRE EITHER
A THIRD PARTY ADD ON OR INVOLVE
A LABORIOUS PROCESS THAT MOST
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THE TECHNICAL
ABILITY OR PATIENCE TO GO
THROUGH. CURRENTLY, EIGHT
STATES, INCLUDING CALIFORNIA,
REQUIRE BUSINESSES TO HONOR
PRIVACY SIGNALS. BROWSER PRIVACY
SIGNALS AS AN OPT OUT OF SALE OF
THEIR PERSONAL INFORMATION. MOST
CONSUMERS ARE UNAWARE OF THE
AMOUNT OF DATA THAT IS HARVESTED
AND DISCLOSED BY COMPANIES
WITHOUT THEIR KNOWLEDGE THAT IS
USED FOR LEVERAGE AND INFLUENCE
THAT IS USED TO LEVERAGE AND
INFLUENCE THEIR BEHAVIORS DAILY.
IF THIS BILL IS PASSED,
CALIFORNIA WOULD BECOME THE
FIRST STATE TO REQUIRE BROWSER
VENDORS TO DIRECTLY SUPPORT
THESE SIGNALS, WHICH WOULD HAVE
SWEEPING BENEFITS. AB 3048 IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY PROTECTION AGENCY AND
SUPPORTED BY SEVERAL PRIVACY
RIGHTS GROUPS. IN THE END, 3048
WILL ENSURE THAT AN INDIVIDUAL'S
RIGHT TO PRIVACY IS UPHELD BY
REQUIRING WEB BROWSERS TO OFFER
EASY TO FIND GLOBAL OPT OUT
SETTINGS SO THAT ANYONE CAN STOP
THE SALE OF THEIR INFORMATION BY
ALL BUSINESSES IF THEY SO
CHOOSE. MY OFFICE AND THE
SPONSOR ARE STILL WORKING OUT
SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH SOME
OF THE AFFECTED COMPANIES, MY
WITNESS IS WITH ME HERE TODAY
ARE MAUREEN MAHONEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PRIVACY PROTECTION
AGENCY. OUR SPONSOR, AND PETER
SNYDER, VICE PRESIDENT OF
ENGINEERING AT BRAVE. OKAY,
GREAT. WE'LL HEAR FROM LEAD
WITNESSES. TWO MINUTES EACH.
CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY. MY NAME IS MAUREEN
MAHONEY. I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF POLICY AND LEGISLATION AT THE
CALIFORNIA PRIVACY PROTECTION
AGENCY. WE IMPLEMENT AND ENFORCE
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY
ACT, AND OUR MISSION IS TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMER
PRIVACY, AND CONSISTENT WITH
THAT MISSION, WE ARE THE PROUD
SPONSOR OF AB 3048. SO ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT ASPECTS OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY
ACT IS THIS EXISTING REQUIREMENT
THAT BUSINESSES RECEIVING WHAT'S
KNOWN AS OPT OUT PREFERENCE
SIGNALS HONOR THEM AS AN OPT OUT
OF SALE AND SHARING OF THE
PERSONAL INFORMATION. SO, FOR
EXAMPLE, IF YOU USE A PRIVACY
FOCUSED BROWSER LIKE BRAVE,
DUCKDUCKGO, OR FIREFOX, IT LETS
YOU SEND AN OPT OUT PREFERENCE
SIGNAL IN THIS CASE KNOWN AS A
GLOBAL PRIVACY CONTROL. AND IF
YOU'RE USING ONE OF THESE
BROWSERS WHEN YOU VISIT A
WEBSITE IN NEW YORK, TIMES.COM,
THAT WILL AUTOMATICALLY GET THE
SIGNAL THAT YOU WANT TO OPT OUT
OF THE SALE AND SHARING OF YOUR
PERSONAL INFORMATION. UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW, NEW YORK TIMES
WOULD HAVE TO HONOR THAT. SO YOU
CAN SEE IT'LL BE MUCH EASIER FOR
CONSUMERS TO EXERCISE THEIR
PRIVACY PREFERENCES THAT WAY,
RATHER THAN GOING TO EVERY SITE
ONE BY ONE AND FILLING OUT A
FORM AND SO ON. SO WE'RE REALLY
ENCOURAGED BY THE PROGRESS
THAT'S BEEN MADE SO FAR. BUT
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED THAT MAJOR
BROWSER VENDORS LIKE GOOGLE
CHROME, APPLE SAFARI AND
MICROSOFT EDGE DON'T OFFER
NATIVE SUPPORT FOR THESE
SIGNALS. SO THIS BILL WOULD
CORRECT THAT REQUIRE BROWSERS TO
OFFER THESE SIGNALS. WE THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY INNOVATION. AN IMPORTANT
NEXT STEP IN IMPLEMENTING THE
CCPA IN A WAY THAT WORKS FOR
CONSUMERS. SO FOR THESE REASONS,
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, MY NAME IS PETE
SNYDER AND I'M AT BRAVE
SOFTWARE. BRAVE SOFTWARE MAKES A
RANGE OF PRIVACY FOCUSED
SOFTWARE AND INTERNET PRODUCTS.
BRAVE STRONGLY SUPPORTS AB 3048
BECAUSE BRAVE BELIEVES BELIEVES
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
USE THE WEB PRIVATELY,
REGARDLESS OF WHAT WEB BROWSER
CALIFORNIANS CHOOSE. THE BRAVE
BROWSER INCLUDES AN OPT OUT
PREFERENCE SIGNAL CALLED GLOBAL
PRIVACY CONTROL, AND HAS DONE SO
FOR OVER THREE YEARS. GLOBAL
PRIVACY CONTROLS IS A NECESSARY
IS A NECESSARY PART OF BRAVE'S
PRIVACY FOCUSED BRAVE. BROWSERS
INCLUDE BEST IN CLASS PRIVACY
FEATURES, WHICH PROTECT USERS
FROM MOST ONLINE PRIVACY RISKS.
BUT THERE ARE OTHER PRIVACY
RISKS THAT CAN'T BE SOLVED WITH
TECHNICAL SOLUTIONS ALONE. RISKS
SUCH AS WEBSITES SELLING AND
SHARING THE KINDS OF DATA USERS
MUST PROVIDE WHEN USING A
WEBSITE. GLOBAL PRIVACY CONTROL
ALLOWS BRAVE TO PROTECT OUR
USERS FROM THESE RISKS IN A
NUMBER OF WAYS THAT TECHNICAL,
TECHNICAL SOLUTIONS ALONE CANNOT
BRAVE. SELECTED GLOBAL PRIVACY
CONTROL IS THE OPT OUT SIGNAL
FOR BROWSERS FOR TWO REASONS.
FIRST, IMPLEMENTING GLOBAL
PRIVACY CONTROLS IN BRAVE WAS
EASY. IT TOOK TWO ENGINEERS JUST
A DAY EACH TO IMPLEMENT GPC
ACROSS OUR PRODUCTS. AND SECOND,
BRAVE SELECTED GLOBAL PRIVACY
CONTROL BECAUSE IT IS EASY FOR
WEBSITES TO RECEIVE AND PROCESS.
BECAUSE GPC IS SIMPLE AND IS A
SIMPLE AND UNAMBIGUOUS SIGNAL OF
A USER USER'S PREFERENCE. SORRY,
BECAUSE GPC IS A SIMPLE AND
UNAMBIGUOUS SIGNAL OF A USER'S
PREFERENCE, WE BELIEVE GPC
PROVIDES THE STRONGEST POSSIBLE
PROTECTIONS FOR USERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND FOR
HEARING FROM ME. I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE'LL TAKE NOW GENERAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. JUST NAME
AFFILIATION. GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON, DANNY CAÑADA
KAISER, ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CYNTHIA
VALENCIA, LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
WITH THE ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
AND SUPPORT. THANKS TRACY
ROSENBERG, ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND
PRIVACY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE, WE'LL TURN NOW TO
OPPOSITION. WELCOME. WE CAN DO
TWO MINUTES IF YOU'D PREFER. OR
YOU CAN JUST STATE A POSITION.
I'M AGAINST. IS THAT OKAY? YES.
IT IS TIME FOR OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. SO TWO MINUTES EACH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MEMBERS
WITH CAL CHAMBER IN OPPOSITION
TO AB 3048. AND THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR. FUNDAMENTALLY, WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE BILL
PREMATURELY MANDATES A UNIVERSAL
OPT OUT PREFERENCE SIGNALS AND
CREATES A SIGNIFICANT COMPLIANCE
QUESTION FOR BUSINESSES
OPERATING ACROSS MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS. OUR MEMBERS
SUPPORT USER CHOICE, WHICH IS
WHY BROWSERS AND DEVICES ALREADY
COMPETE IN OFFERING CLEAR,
EFFECTIVE USER CONTROLS OVER
DATA USES, ALLOWING USERS TO
CHOOSE APPS OR EXTENSIONS TO
MANAGE THEIR PRIVACY PREFERENCES
IN A CENTRALIZED MANNER. AND
WITH THE PASSAGE OF PROP 24,
VOTERS LAID THE GROUNDWORK FOR
ENCOURAGING BUT NOT REQUIRING
BUSINESSES TO INCREASINGLY
INCORPORATE AND RECOGNIZE GLOBAL
OPT OUT PREFERENCE SIGNALS.
UNDER THE CCPA. RECOGNIZING THE
COMPLEXITY OF IMPLEMENTING AN
OPT OUT PREFERENCE SIGNAL, THE
PROPOSITION REQUIRES THE AGENCY
TO ADOPT REGULATIONS THAT MUST
MEET CERTAIN SPECIFICATIONS. FOR
EXAMPLE, THEY MUST BE FREE OF
DEFAULTS THAT PRESUPPOSE
CONSUMER INTENT, BE CLEARLY
DESCRIBED, AND EASY TO USE, AND
NOT CONFLICT WITH OTHER COMMONLY
USED PRIVACY SETTINGS OR TOOLS.
WHILE ONLINE DEVICES AND
ADVERTISERS ARE CAPABLE OF
DISTINGUISHING DATA USES BY
JURISDICTION, INCLUDING FOR
CALIFORNIA USERS, DEVICES AND
SOFTWARE ARE THAT ARE OFFERED
GLOBALLY TO BILLIONS OF USERS
CANNOT BE EASILY ALTERED FOR
CALIFORNIA USERS ALONE. IT'S
UNCLEAR TO US WHAT AN OPT OUT
PREFERENCE SIGNAL LOOKS LIKE
WHEN THERE ARE DIFFERENT STATES
PROPOSING DIFFERENT OPT OUT
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL. ARE WE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE DIFFERENT
CONTROLS FOR EVERY STATE OR
JURISDICTION? FOR EVERY
MECHANISM OR CONSUMERS TO BE
ALLOWED TO REVERSE THEIR
DECISION TO OPT BACK IN? THERE'S
MANY OTHER QUESTIONS. I WILL SAY
. WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
AMENDMENT, THE ANALYSIS CHANGES
DEVICE TO, I'M FORGETTING THE
TERMINOLOGY. IT CHANGES IT TO
APOLOGIES. BUT WE ARE TAKING A
LOOK AT THAT TO MOBILE OPERATING
SYSTEM. SORRY. WE ARE TAKING A
LOOK AT THAT. AND WE ARE
DISCUSSING WITH OUR MEMBERS. WE
ARE CONCERNED STILL THAT THE
BILL INCLUDES RULEMAKING, WHERE
THE TERM WOULD BE FURTHER
DEFINED AND HAVE FURTHER
REQUIREMENTS. SO IT'S DIFFICULT
FOR US TO ASSESS IT RIGHT NOW.
SO WE ARE OPPOSED. BUT WE DO
THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION,
DYLAN HOFFMAN, ON BEHALF OF
TECHNET, RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
THANKS THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS?
NAOMI PIDGEON, ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPUTER AND COMMUNICATIONS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SEEING NO
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION, WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DÍAS
MEMBERS. QUESTIONS, COMMENTS,
MOTIONS. I'LL MOVE MOTION FROM
SENATOR WILK, THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. TRYING TO
FURTHER THE PURPOSES OF CCPA
HERE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO
CLOSE IF YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. THANKS
ALL RIGHT, THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS, AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS, MOTION FROM
SENATOR WILK. OKAY. THANK YOU.
THIS IS FILE ITEM 28, AB 3048.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE, BERG. WILK WILK. AYE.
ALLEN ASHBY. CABALLERO DURAZZO.
LAIRD LAIRD. AYE. NILO ROTH.
STERN. STERN. AYE WAHAB. THAT'S
3 TO 0 WITH MEMBERS MISSING. ALL
RIGHT. VERY GOOD. WE'LL MOVE ON
TO YOUR NEXT BILL. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND SENATORS, I WOULD
LIKE TO PRESENT AB 2481 YOUTH
SOCIAL MEDIA PROTECTION ACT, AND
I WANT TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS, EXPRESS IMMENSE
GRATITUDE FOR THE THOUGHTFUL AND
DETAILED WORK AND ANALYSIS MADE
TO STRENGTHEN THIS BILL WITHOUT
ERODING ITS VITAL GOALS TO FORM
A PIPELINE OF COLLABORATION
BETWEEN SCHOOL OFFICIALS AND
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS TO TURN
THE TIDE IN THIS CURRENT CRISIS
IN YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH. AB 2481
THE YOUTH SOCIAL MEDIA
PROTECTION ACT WILL PROVIDE
VITAL PROTECTION FOR OUR YOUTH
BY REQUIRING SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS TO PROVIDE TIMELY
RESPONSES TO SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS, WHO RAISE
CONCERN THAT A SPECIFIC CONTENT
MAY BE IN VIOLATION OF A
PLATFORM'S TERMS AND CONDITIONS
AND CONTENT POLICIES, FURTHER
CREATES A VERIFIED REPORTING
MECHANISM TO AUTHENTICATE
TRUSTED SCHOOL LEADERS AND
LICENSED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS SO THAT THE
PLATFORM CAN LEVERAGE THE SCHOOL
PROFESSIONALS JUDGMENT IN
ASSESSING THE MATERIAL RISK TO A
CHILD. USERS HEALTH AND SAFETY.
SUCH REPORTS WILL TRIGGER AN
EXPEDITED HUMAN REVIEW BY THE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM WITH A
TIMELY RESPONSE. IT IS, QUITE
SIMPLY, THE VILLAGE APPROACH TO
SOLVING CRISES ONLINE. FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE. OUR CHILDREN.
SO WHY IS THIS BILL NECESSARY?
LIKE ALL OF YOU, I WANT THESE
COMPANIES TO THRIVE AND ADDING
CAPITAL EXPENDITURE OR
OPERATIONAL EXPENSES WITHOUT
ACCOMPANYING REVENUE MAY NOT
SEEM TO MAKE THEM MORE
SUCCESSFUL. I SHOULD TAKE THIS
TIME TO ACKNOWLEDGE HOW HARD
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES ARE
WORKING TO SELF-REGULATE THE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS OF OUR
YOUTH, AND I BELIEVE THEY DO NOT
WANT ANY UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
FROM OUR ONLINE BEHAVIOR. BUT
SELF-REGULATION IS A FAILURE AND
ALL WE NEED TO DO IS LOOK AT THE
DATA. IT'S OVERWHELMING. YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE SPENDING ON AVERAGE
OF FIVE HOURS PER DAY ON SOCIAL
MEDIA. SUICIDE RATES OF YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THE UNITED STATES HAS
INCREASED 62% SINCE 2011. 22% OF
CURRENT HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
HAVE CONSIDERED SUICIDE. 22% OF
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. CDC STUDY
FOUND THAT NEARLY 30% OF U.S.
TEEN GIRLS SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED
TAKING THEIR OWN LIVES. CHILDREN
AND YOUNG PEOPLE WERE VICTIM OF
CYBERBULLYING, WERE TWICE AS
MORE LIKELY TO ENGAGE IN
SELF-HARM AND SUICIDAL BEHAVIORS
THAN THEIR NON-VICTIM PEERS, AND
THE FINDINGS ALSO INDICATED THAT
PERPETRATORS OF CYBERBULLYING
WERE AT INCREASED RISK FOR
SUICIDAL THOUGHTS AND BEHAVIORS.
FINALLY, OF COURSE, SURGEON
GENERAL IS NOW RECOMMENDING
WARNING LABELS ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS FOR THE ADVERSE
IMPACTS ON MENTAL HEALTH TO OUR
YOUTH. SO THIS BILL IS
ULTIMATELY ABOUT LIFE OR DEATH.
HOW DO WE TURN THESE NUMBERS
AROUND IF WE CAN BE RESPONSIBLE
ENOUGH TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS IN CHILDREN IS
TIED TO THE CORRESPONDING MASS
USAGE OF SOCIAL MEDIA BY OUR
YOUTH. WHAT ARE WE AFFIRMATIVELY
DOING TO TURN THIS TIDE RIGHT?
IS IT SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
RELYING ON SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES TO DO ON THEIR OWN? DO
THEY HAVE THE CONTEXT TO
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITIES OF A
GIVEN BULLYING SITUATION? OR IF
SOMETHING IS TRIGGERING A
SPECIFIC COMMUNITY OR AS SOMEONE
IS PRECARIOUSLY CLOSE TO
SELF-HARM, DO THEY UNDERSTAND
GANG SIGNS? DO THEY UNDERSTAND
WHAT SOMETHING IS OFFENSIVE TO
NATIVE AMERICANS OR TO THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY? DOES THE DATA
SHOW THAT, GIVEN THEIR STATED
HERCULEAN EFFORTS ON BEING
RESPONSIVE TO HARMFUL CONTENT,
THAT THEY'RE TURNING THINGS
AROUND? WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT
IS ABOUT CREATING A VILLAGE TO
ASSIST THESE COMPANIES TO
UNDERSTAND CONTEXT, TO BE
ALERTED IN THE MIDST OF A
CRISIS, TO LEAN ON THE INPUT OF
LOCAL PROFESSIONALS. ALL OF US
ALREADY ENTRUST WITH OUR
CHILDREN'S SAFETY. CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATIONAL LEADERS AND LICENSED
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS THAT
REGULARLY BEAR WITNESS TO
SEVERAL HARMS BEING INFLICTED
UPON OUR YOUTH DUE TO CONTENT ON
SOCIAL MEDIA. WHILE HAVING NO
MEANS TO ADDRESS SUCH CONTENT
AND PROTECT THE CHILDREN IN
THEIR CARE THEY WANT TO AND THEY
CAN HELP ONLY IF WE ENABLE THEM
TO DO SO. NOW THE OPPOSITION IS
WORKING, VERY WORKING. THIS BILL
VERY HARD AND THAT'S NATURAL.
THIS IS GROUNDBREAKING
LEGISLATION THAT THE REST OF THE
NATION AND PERHAPS THE REST OF
THE WORLD WILL FOLLOW. IF THIS
LEGISLATION PASSES. WE HAVE MET
WITH THE OPPOSITION MANY TIMES.
IF YOU READ THEIR LETTER OR SIT
WITH THEM, THEY'LL EXPLAIN TO
YOU ABOUT THE COLLECTIVE ACTION
PROBLEM, ABOUT SETTING A
VERIFIED SYSTEM UP, HOW
COMPLIANCE IS, QUOTE, UNDEFINED
AND SUBJECTIVE. HOW, QUOTE, THE
BILL'S ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS
MAY FAIL TO ADEQUATELY ACHIEVE
INTENDED GOALS. THEY'RE TRYING
TO SAY IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK,
WHICH IS MADDENING BECAUSE OF
COURSE IT WILL WORK. THEIR
COMMENTS ARE SUBTERFUGE. WHAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY SAYING IS THAT
THEY DON'T WANT TO SPEND THE
MONEY ON A HUMAN CONTACT CENTER,
BECAUSE THERE'S NO REVENUE
ATTACHED TO IT FOR THEM, ONLY
COST. THAT'S BEEN THEIR MAIN
POINT THIS ENTIRE TIME. AND HOW
DID WE GET THERE? WELL, AROUND
25 YEARS AGO, AS THE INTERNET
EXPLODED, WE SOMEHOW MANAGED TO
SET OUR OWN EXPECTATIONS ON
CUSTOMER SERVICE, THINKING THAT
IF PRODUCTS ARE FREE, THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO HAVE CONTACT
CENTERS. SO PAID PRODUCTS AND
TECH LIKE APPLE OR SOFTWARE
COMPANIES ALL HAVE CUSTOMER
CARE. BUT SOCIAL AND CONTENT
PLATFORMS TYPICALLY DON'T. YOU
CAN'T CALL YOUTUBE, YOU CAN'T
CALL GOOGLE OR INSTAGRAM OR
TIKTOK OR SNAPCHAT, DESPITE THE
FACT THAT WE NOW KNOW THAT
NOTHING IS ACTUALLY FREE.
THEY'RE MAKING BILLIONS OFF OF
US. THE LONGER WE STAY ONLINE,
THE MORE THEY MAKE AND BILLIONS
OFF OUR CHILDREN. DESPITE THE
HORRIFIC MENTAL HEALTH OUTCOMES
FOR YOUTH ONLINE, CAN THEY
AFFORD HUMAN REVIEW WHEN
ESCALATED BY A SCHOOL PRINCIPAL?
WELL, META MADE $39 BILLION
PROFIT IN 2023. A 69% INCREASE
FROM THE YEAR BEFORE. ALPHABET
MADE 42 BILLION, A 40% INCREASE
FROM THE YEAR BEFORE. A CONTACT
CENTER TO HANDLE THIS WOULD BE
DE MINIMIS GIVEN THEIR MASSIVE
GROWTH ON THE BACKS OF OUR
FUTURE GENERATION. IF THEY WERE
SOLUTIONS MINDED AND NOT SIMPLY
IN THE WAY THEY COULD EVEN SHARE
A CONTACT CENTER THE SAME WAY
THEY SHARE THEIR LOBBYING
EFFORTS AND DIVIDE COSTS BASED
ON A PERCENTAGE OF INBOUND
CONTACTS RECEIVED. IN THE END,
THERE'S ZERO CHANCE WE WOULD
ACQUIESCE TO THEIR DEMAND FOR
AUTOMATED REVIEW AND ONLY HUMAN.
ONCE SOMETHING HAS BEEN
ESCALATED, THE FACTS ARE
OVERWHELMING AND WE MUST INSIST
ON EXPEDITED HUMAN REVIEW WHEN A
CHILD'S LIFE COULD BE IN DANGER.
WE'VE AGREED TO AMENDMENTS TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF TRIGGERS
THAT FLAG AN EXPEDITED REVIEW
NARROWED WHO CAN BE VERIFIED
REPORTERS TO JUST PRINCIPALS AND
LICENSED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS, BOTH OF WHICH CAN
BE VERIFIED ONLINE THROUGH
PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE DATABASES
MAINTAINED BY THE STATE. WE'VE
REMOVED THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT, ALTHOUGH I DO
RECOMMEND TO INDUSTRY
AFFIRMATIVE COLLABORATION ON
DATA WITH PUBLIC OFFICIALS TO
GET TO THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM,
AND WE FINALLY, WE REMOVED THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION. MY
FAMILY ALONE. I'VE EXPERIENCED
WAY TOO MANY TIMES. MY CHILDREN
OR THEIR FRIENDS HAVE BEEN
DEEPLY AFFECTED BY CONTENT THAT
TAKES THEM TO A DARK PLACE. I'VE
WORKED WITH SCHOOL OFFICIALS WHO
ARE AT WIT'S END, WHO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THIS DAY IN AND DAY
OUT WITH NO PARTNER IN TECH TO
WORK WITH. I'VE HEARD STORIES
FROM PARENTS WHO HAVE HAD TO
MOVE. THEY'VE HAD TO CHANGE
SCHOOLS, OR THEY'VE EVEN LOST
CHILDREN TO EATING DISORDERS,
ADDICTION AND SUICIDE. THE FACT
IS THAT PERVASIVE HARM IS BEING
INFLICTED ON CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH
THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA. YET SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS CONTINUE TO
FAIL, AND PROVIDING A MINIMALLY
SUFFICIENT RESPONSE TIME TO THE
THREATS EITHER THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM PROVIDES NO RESPONSE,
OR THE RESPONSE COMES FAR TOO
LATE AFTER SIGNIFICANT HARM IS
DONE. IT'S MY BELIEF THEY JUST
CAN'T DO THIS ALONE. AND WHO
BETTER TO HELP THEM THAN THOSE
WE ENTRUST THE SAFETY OF OUR
CHILDREN DAILY? MY WITNESS TODAY
IS MARK BERMAN, THE CEO OF THE
ORGANIZATION FOR SOCIAL MEDIA
SAFETY. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MUCH
WELCOME. MR. BERKMAN, TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU SO MUCH, GOOD
AFTERNOON. COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
MARK BERKMAN. I'M THE CEO OF THE
ORGANIZATION FOR SOCIAL MEDIA
SAFETY. WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR
AB 2481, THE YOUTH SOCIAL MEDIA
PROTECTION ACT, SOCIAL MEDIA IS
HARMING MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN. CYBER BULLYING,
EXTORTION, DRUG TRAFFICKING,
VIOLENCE AND MORE TRAGICALLY,
THE SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS ARE
NOT TAKING SUFFICIENT STEPS TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN FROM THESE
HARMS. 80% OF PEOPLE SAY THAT
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS ARE DOING
IT ONLY FAIR OR POOR JOB AT
ADDRESSING HARASSMENT. ONLY 14%
OF THOSE WHO EXPERIENCED A
PHYSICAL THREAT SAID THE
PLATFORM DELETED THE THREATENING
CONTENT. AB 2481 WILL ENABLE OUR
TRUSTED CHILD WELFARE EXPERTS.
CALIFORNIA'S K THROUGH 12
PRINCIPALS AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO ISSUE A REPORT
TO A SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM OF
CONTENT THAT POSES A RISK OR A
SEVERE RISK TO A CHILD, AND THEN
RECEIVE A HUMAN EXPEDITED REVIEW
AND RESPONSE FROM THE PLATFORM.
THIS WOULD CREATE A COST FREE,
DEPENDABLE STATEWIDE TRIAGE
SYSTEM PREVENTING SOME OF THESE
SEVERE SOCIAL MEDIA RELATED HARM
WE SEE ON A REGULAR BASIS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. WE CONTINUE TO SEE
EDUCATORS IN TEARS OVER SOCIAL
MEDIA CONTENT REPRESENTING AN
ONGOING, IMMINENT THREAT TO THE
SAFETY OF THEIR CHILD, CHARGES
ONE PASADENA BASED PRINCIPAL
TOLD US HE REGULARLY ENCOUNTERS
SOCIAL MEDIA, DISTRIBUTED SEXUAL
RUMORS, HATE BASED HARASSMENT
AND BULLYING, HE SAID. WHEN WE
TAGGED THEM ON THE PLATFORM,
THEY ARE NOT TAKEN DOWN, NOR DO
I OFTEN EVEN GET A LEGITIMATE
RESPONSE FROM THE PARTY.
TRAGICALLY, THESE POSTS HAVE,
QUOTE LED TO STUDENTS IN THE
SCHOOL HAVING SUICIDAL IDEATIONS
OR SUICIDAL ATTEMPTS, GIVING OUR
TRUSTED PROFESSIONALS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE AN URGENT
REPORT OF HARM TO SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS IS A REASONABLE,
BALANCED INTERVENTION THAT WILL
SAVE CHILDREN'S LIVES. TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN, I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. I ALSO WANT TO TAKE THE
LAST TWO SECONDS, TWO SECONDS TO
THANK THE BILL. AUTHOR, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOWENTHAL AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NOW'S THE TIME. NAME GROUP
AFFILIATION. POSITION. OKAY.
SEEING NONE, WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. COME ON. FORWARD. I
THINK WE'RE GONNA AFFORD YOU.
TWO MINUTES. SHADE OVER THAT FOR
EQUAL TIME. WELCOME. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. DYLAN HOFFMAN, ON
BEHALF OF TECHNET. AND WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO AB 2481.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY AT THE
OUTSET THAT WE DO UNDERSTAND THE
GRAVE IMPORTANCE OF THIS ISSUE.
WE FULLY AGREE WITH THE INTENT
OF THIS BILL. OUR COMPANIES HAVE
A VERY LONG HISTORY OF
ESTABLISHING INDUSTRY BEST
PRACTICES AND CREATING NEW
FEATURES AND TOOLS TO PROVIDE
PARENTS WITH GREATER CONTROL
OVER THEIR CHILD'S SOCIAL MEDIA
EXPERIENCE. BUT WE DO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS MORE WORK TO BE
DONE AND WANT TO BE PART OF
THAT. THAT SOLUTION. WE'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 2481 AS IT IS
CURRENTLY IN PRINT. WE,
ACKNOWLEDGE THE AMENDMENTS NOTED
IN THE ANALYSIS THAT THEY MAY
TOUCH ON SOME OF OUR MAIN
CONCERNS, BUT WITHOUT SEEING THE
LANGUAGE, CAN'T COMMENT DIRECTLY
TO WHAT EXTENT THEY WILL WANT TO
FLAG A COUPLE OF ISSUES, THOUGH,
WITH THIS BILL, AS WE CONTINUE
TO SEE IT MOVING FORWARD. FIRST,
WE CONTINUE TO SEE THE VERIFIED
REPORTER PROVISION AS
PROBLEMATIC. THE REMOVAL OF
SCHOOL COUNSELORS IS AN
IMPROVEMENT, BUT THE ENTIRE
STRUCTURE IS PROBLEMATIC FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE. WE DON'T HAVE A
CLEAR IDEA OF HOW WE WOULD
EFFECTIVELY TRACK THE STATUS OF
POTENTIALLY TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
VERIFIED REPORTERS IN THE STATE.
FURTHER, THE BILL LIMITS US TO
VERIFYING THESE INDIVIDUALS
EVERY TWO YEARS, AND WE DON'T
KNOW HOW WE'RE SUPPOSED TO KNOW
IF THEY'RE STILL A PRINCIPAL, IF
THEY'VE BEEN LET GO BY A
DISTRICT, OR IF A LICENSED
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL STILL
HOLDS THAT LICENSE. SECOND, THE
SCOPE OF SOCIAL MEDIA THREATS IN
THE BILL IS TO EXPANSIVE TO THE
EXTENT THAT EVERYTHING IS
PRIORITIZED, NOTHING IS
PRIORITIZED. AND WE NOTE THAT
THE AMENDMENTS TO THIS PORTION
OF THE BILL SEEK TO NARROW THAT,
AND WE'LL REVIEW THAT LANGUAGE
WHEN IT'S AVAILABLE. THIRD, WE
THINK THE TIME FRAMES NEED SOME
WORK. THE BILL CURRENTLY
REQUIRES PLATFORMS TO DECIDE
WHETHER CONTENT VIOLATES OUR
TERMS OR CONDITIONS WITHIN 72
HOURS, OR 24, IF THE RISK IS
SEVERE. THE LEGISLATURE LAST
YEAR ADOPTED A 30 DAY STANDARD
FOR MAKING THE SAME
DETERMINATION FOR CHILD SEXUAL
ABUSE MATERIAL IN AB 1394 BY
SIMILAR WICKS LAST YEAR. IF THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO ELEVATE ALL
OF THESE TYPES OF SOCIAL MEDIA
THREATS, THAT'S A CONVERSATION
THAT WE'RE WILLING TO ENGAGE IN,
BUT JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT WE DO
EXPECT A SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER
VOLUME OF SOME OF THESE
CATEGORIES OF CONTENT THAN WE DO
FOR KI¾M. AND THERE IS AN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF SORT
OF IDENTIFYING WHERE THE
PRIORITIES AND INVESTMENTS
SHOULD, SHOULD LAY. SO I WANT TO
BE VERY CLEAR. WE'RE NOT LEGISLATION
ON THE SUBJECT THAT CAN BE
EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENTED. FEDERAL
PREEMPTION ISSUES AND
CONSTITUTIONAL PROBLEMS. AND TO
THAT END, WE HAVE OFFERED THE
AUTHOR AMENDMENTS TO A VERSION
OF THIS BILL THAT WOULD CREATE A
STANDARDIZED REPORTING MECHANISM
FOR ALL POTENTIALLY VIOLATIVE
CONTENT OF OUR TERMS AND
SERVICES. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THAT. AND MANY OTHER IDEAS, BUT
I WANT TO FLAG THAT OUR
COALITION AND OUR MEMBERS ARE
MAKING GOOD, A GOOD FAITH EFFORT
TO BE CONSTRUCTIVE. I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR, HIS STAFF, THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL, FOR
MEETING WITH US TO HEAR OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL AND
TALK TO US ABOUT POTENTIAL
PATHWAYS TO WORKING TOGETHER.
GREAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION,
THANK YOU. DAWN KOEPKE ON BEHALF
OF THE COMPUTER AND
COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY. THANKS ALLOW ME ON BEHALF
OF CAL CHAMBER OPPOSE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SEEING NO OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION, WE'LL TAKE YOU BACK
TO THE DAIS. MEMBERS QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR MEMBER QUESTION
COMMENTS? YES. MR. VICE CHAIR.
YES. YEAH. I'D LIKE TO LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT. SO I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. AND I
TALKED ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN MY
JUNIOR HIGH WHEN I MET WITH THEM
AFTER WE HAD A SHOOTING AT THE
HIGH SCHOOL. BUT YOU SAID
SOMETHING TODAY THAT I THINK IS,
IS PROBABLY NOT. YOU'RE BEING
GENEROUS, BUT PROBABLY NOT
CORRECT WHERE YOU SAID THESE
THESE COMPANIES ARE TRYING TO DO
THE BEST JOB THEY CAN. AND I'M
LOOKING AT HIM, BUT IT APPLIES
TO YOU, I GUESS I DON'T I DON'T
THINK THEY ARE. I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU EVER SAW THAT MOVIE BREXIT.
IT WAS PRODUCED BY BBC. YOU CAN
GET IT ON HBO DEMAND. AND IN
THERE THE POLITICAL CONSULTANTS
ARE TALKING WITH TECH GUYS AND
THEY'RE SAYING FACEBOOK KNOWS
WHEN YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE AN
AFFAIR BEFORE YOU DO. BECAUSE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THESE
ALGORITHMS. SO I THINK THIS
COULD ACTUALLY EVEN BE MORE
PROACTIVE THAN, THAN IT IS IN
TERMS OF PROTECTING KIDS. AND
THEY'RE NOT DOING IT AND THEY'RE
NOT DOING IT BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO MAKE MONEY. AND SO STRONGLY
SUPPORT YOUR BILL AND BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY, THANK YOU.
I'LL, I'LL ADD ON MY GRATITUDE,
WE'VE BEEN AT THIS ISSUE
TOGETHER. DADS UNITED. SOMEWHAT
DISAPPOINTED ABOUT THE NARROWING
OF THE SCOPE. I WILL SAY, BUT I
DO LOOK FORWARD TO THE TECH
INDUSTRY'S RESPONSE. NOW THAT,
SOME OF THESE THAT, YOU KNOW,
SORT OF NOT EVERYTHING IS
COVERED AND IT'S GOING TO BE
MUCH MORE TAILORED AND SPECIFIC.
THE DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION TO
GET OUR HEADS AROUND IT. THE
LICENSED PROFESSIONALS, AND
PRINCIPALS, THE LIMITATION
THERE, I THINK, THE BILL SHOULD
BE IN A POSITION THAT YOU ALL
CAN COME TO, TO, TO GET TO. YES.
BECAUSE I CAN IMAGINE IT'S AN
UNCOMFORTABLE POSITION TO BE
OPPOSING VERY COMMON SENSE
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS. SO REALLY
LOOKING TO YOU ALL TO DIG IN
DEEP AND CAREFULLY REVIEW THESE
VERY AGGRESSIVE, BUT, I GUESS
NECESSARY AMENDMENTS, AND ALLOW
YOU TO CLOSE, THANK YOU,
SENATORS, FOR YOUR VERY
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS. I FIRST
WANT TO SAY HOW PROUD I AM TO
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS
ISSUE, AS IT SHOULD BE, AS MOST
ISSUES IN THE STATE SHOULD BE.
AND IT'S JUST COMFORTING WHEN
PEOPLE COME TOGETHER TO DO THE
RIGHT THING, I WANT TO COMMEND
THE OPPOSITION FOR ALWAYS COMING
IN AND, YOU KNOW, HAVING TO SAY,
WORDS ON VERY, VERY TOUGH BILLS
FOR THEM, DYLAN MADE COMMENT IN
PARTICULAR ABOUT THE INDUSTRY
HAVING A LONG HISTORY OF BEST
PRACTICES. AND I'M QUITE CERTAIN
THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE INSIDE
THESE ORGANIZATIONS THAT WANT TO
DO MORE FOR OUR YOUTH. BUT THIS
LONG HISTORY OF BEST PRACTICES
IS NOT YIELDING THE RESULTS THAT
WE NEED. THE DATA IS SHOWING US
THAT IT'S GETTING WORSE, NOT
BETTER. WE HAVE TO CHANGE
THINGS. WE HAVE TO, OR ELSE THE
OUTCOMES ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO GET WORSE AND WORSE. I THINK
THAT THERE, YOU KNOW, IN IN MY
DIALOG WITH SCHOOL OFFICIALS,
THEY'RE AT WIT'S END AND THEY
NEED THIS. SO WE NEED TO SUPPORT
THEM AS WELL AS THEY TRY AND
PROVIDE A FOUNDATION OF
STABILITY FOR OUR YOUTH. AND
THIS IS A KEY COMPONENT OF THIS.
WITH THAT, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
IS I WOULD JUST STATE FOR THE
RECORD, I'D LOVE TO BE ADDED AS
COAUTHOR WHEN THE TIME PERMITS,
DO WE HAVE A MOTION? YES. MOTION
FROM SENATOR WILK, MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS, NOT. NO, NO, NO,
IT'S Dð PASS AS AMENDED TO PASS
AS AMENDED. OKAY. THAT'S IT.
THAT'S IT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THANK YOU. THIS IS, FILE ITEM
27. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED. IT'S AB 2481. BERG WILK
WILK. I ALLEN ASHBY. GUERRERO
DURAZZO. LAIRD. NILO ROTH.
STERN. STERN I WAHAB. THAT'S 2
TO 0 WITH MEMBERS MISSING. GOING
TO LEAVE IT OPEN. ALL RIGHT.
VERY GOOD, LOOKING TO VERY
PATIENT. MR. LOWE DEFERRING TO
MR. MAIENSCHEIN. WELCOME, MR.
MAIENSCHEIN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR MR. I CAN SEE THAT,
PLEASE, WE'LL LEAVE IT TO YOUR
DISCRETION. YOU WELL, YOU'RE
YOU'RE ARE YOU 2016. YEAH LET'S
JUST DO 26. I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
TWO, TWO ITEMS FOR US, 2016 AND
2159. I DO, MR. CHAIR, AND LET
ME, IF IT'S OKAY WITH THE CHAIR,
WE'LL START WITH AB 2016. VERY
WELL. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS TODAY WE
FACE A CRITICAL ISSUE AFFECTING
MANY LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA. THE
RAPID ESCALATION OF HOME VALUES.
THIS SURGE IN PROPERTY PRICES
HAS RESULTED IN ESTATES THAT
INCLUDE MODEST FAMILY HOMES NO
LONGER QUALIFYING FOR AN
EXPEDITED PROBATE PROCESS TO
ADDRESS THIS CHALLENGE AND
PROTECT THE INTERGENERATIONAL
TRANSFER OF WEALTH FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES, PROUD TO PRESENT AB
2016. THIS BILL AIMS TO UPDATE
THE VALUE OF ESTATES ELIGIBLE
FOR THE STATE'S EXPEDITED SMALL
ESTATE PROBATE PROCESS BY
INCREASING THE VALUE OF THE
SMALL ESTATE VALUE TO $750,000.
AB 2016 WOULD EMPOWER FAR MORE
LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME HEIRS TO
UTILIZE THE EXPEDITED PROCESS.
WHEN INHERITING THE FAMILY HOME.
THIS WOULD NOT ONLY ENSURE
SMOOTHER TRANSITIONS, BUT ALSO
SAVE PRECIOUS COURT RESOURCES
AND REDUCE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ABUSE DURING PROBATE
PROCEEDINGS. FURTHERMORE, IT
WOULD PREVENT HEIRS FROM BEING
CAUGHT UP IN CALIFORNIA'S
LENGTHY PROBATE PROCESS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN TRYING TO
ESTABLISH TITLE TO THE FAMILY
HOME AFTER THE PASSING OF A
LOVED ONE. IN ESSENCE, THIS BILL
IS ABOUT PRESERVING
INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH AND
PROVIDING FAMILIES WITH THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED DURING
CHALLENGING TIMES. THANK YOU,
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT AS MAEVE ELISE BROWN
FROM HOUSING AND ECONOMIC RIGHTS
ADVOCATES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU BET. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE. I AM HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL, HAVING
SEEN DURING THE YEARS OF THE
FORECLOSURE CRISIS WHEN MANY,
MANY FAMILIES AND WERE SET TO
INHERIT THE FAMILY HOME AND
WERE, TRAPPED BECAUSE TITLE WAS
NOT DECIDED UPON, AND THEY COULD
NOT OBTAIN A LOAN MODIFICATION
UNTIL TITLE HAD BEEN DETERMINED.
AND THIS BILL COULD GO A LONG
WAY TOWARDS ALLEVIATING FUTURE
PROBLEMS AS PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE AND OUR POPULATION IS
AGING, AND THERE ARE A LOT MORE
PROPERTIES THAT ARE PASSED IN
THESE COMING OF YEARS,
ESPECIALLY FOR THE ADULT
CHILDREN, BECAUSE MANY SURVIVING
SPOUSES CAN STILL UTILIZE AN
EXPEDITED PROCESS. BUT THE KIDS
CANNOT, WE ALSO AT OUR OFFICE,
WE PROVIDE FREE LEGAL SERVICES
STATEWIDE AND FOCUS ON HOUSEHOLD
DEBT AND CREDIT ISSUES. AND WE
SEE A LOT OF SURVIVING HEIRS
BEING TARGETED FOR PROBATE,
ADVANCE LOANS AND HAVING OTHER
PEOPLE KNOCK ON THE DOOR AND
TRYING TO GET THEM TO SIGN OVER
A PORTION OF THEIR, FUTURE
INTEREST IN THE PROPERTY. AND SO
THEY'RE THEY'RE HANGING OUT.
THEY'RE LOSING THE FAMILY HOME,
EVEN BEFORE THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
REALLY ACTUALLY INHERIT. SO
THANK YOU. SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS,
PLEASE. NO FURTHER WITNESSES.
ALL RIGHT. ALL THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF AB 2016, PLEASE COME FORWARD
SEEING NO ONE ELSE COMING
FORWARD. OPPOSITION TO AB 2016.
PLEASE COME FORWARD EITHER TO
THE MICROPHONE OR THE CHAIR. AND
I APOLOGIZE FOR THE HEAT IN THIS
ROOM. I REALIZE IT'S GETTING TO
BE A PLACE WHERE IT'S ALMOST
UNCONSCIONABLE, BUT GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU, MR. CAL OSHA
COMPLAINT. YEAH, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN, MY NAME IS ALBERT NHÀ.
I'M A CALIFORNIA PROBATE REFEREE
AND A LONG TIME ATTORNEY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, AND I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA PROBATE REFEREES
ASSOCIATION, WE UNANIMOUSLY
OPPOSE THIS, NOT BECAUSE IT
AFFECTS US. WE'RE STILL GOING TO
BE, MAKING THESE APPRAISALS
UNDER THIS, UNDER THIS BILL, BUT
BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN ASSIGNED TO
ALL THESE ESTATES, AND IT'S VERY
RARE THAT YOUR OPPOSITION IS
GOING TO BE FOR THE SAME REASONS
THAT THE PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL
ARE PROMOTING IT. WE SEE
FIRSTHAND THE FORECLOSURE
PROBLEMS. WE SEE FIRSTHAND THE
ONEROUS LENDING PROBLEMS WE SEE
FIRSTHAND. YOU KNOW, THE
DIFFICULTIES WITH GOING BACK AND
FORTH AND THROUGH THE PROCESS
AND THE PROBATE SYSTEM FOR THESE
PEOPLE WHO ARE HAVE A LIMITED
WEALTH AND MOST OF THEM OVER 50%
THAT WE ESTIMATE HAVE THEIR
TOTAL WEALTH TIED UP INTO THEIR
RESIDENCE. AND THIS IS THIS IS
WHAT THE PROBATE SYSTEM IS
ENTIRELY FOR, TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE WEALTH OF THIS FAMILY IS
GOING TO BE PUT BACK INTO THE
INTO THE PROGRAM. THERE IS NO
PROTECTION FOR THE PAYMENT OF
UNPAID TAXES TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THERE'S NO
PROTECTION FOR THE OBLIGATIONS
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES
WERE GIVEN. THERE'S NO
PROTECTIONS FOR MONIES THAT ARE
DUE UNDER THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION ACT. ALL OF WHICH
IS PROVIDED FOR IN THE PROBATE
CODE. WE THINK THAT THAT THIS IS
A BAND AID, WHICH IS GOING TO
CAUSE A TREMENDOUS INCREASE IN
LITIGATION AND FAMILY PROBLEMS
AND DO EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE FOR
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF FAMILIES
THAT THE PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL
PROMOTE. THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHED
THE MICROPHONE. LET US NOW TURN
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBER. DO
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS? SENATOR
WILK, I JUST THROW IT OUT TO THE
AUTHOR IF YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO
WHAT WAS JUST SHARED. YEAH,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK. WE'VE WE'VE
HAD PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS ON
THIS BILL. WE'LL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT, OVER THE RECESS. CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THEIR FEEDBACK, YOU
KNOW, WE DON'T WANT TO OBVIOUSLY
HAVE ADVERSE IMPACTS TO WHAT
THIS IS INTENDED. I THINK IT'S
CLEAR, THOUGH, AT ITS CORE, YOU
KNOW, THE CURRENT ESTATE VALUE
IS $184,000 FOR A HOME. I DON'T
THINK ANY OF US KNOW WHERE YOU
COULD PAY IN CALIFORNIA.
$184,000 FOR HOME. LOOKING AT
THE TWO OF YOU UP THERE, I DON'T
THINK YOU HAVE A SINGLE HOME IN
YOUR DISTRICT THAT THAT WOULD
THAT. OKAY, WELL, YOU MIGHT HAVE
ONE THEN. THAT'S GREAT, FOR
184,000. BUT FOR MOST PEOPLE,
THE REASON WE CAME TO THE FIGURE
OF $750,000 IS, ACCORDING TO
ZILLOW, YOU KNOW, JUST USING
THAT AS SORT OF A CLEARINGHOUSE,
THAT'S THE AVERAGE PRICE OF A
HOME. SO WE DO HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT, OBVIOUSLY,
HOUSING HAS GONE UP FROM A TIME
WHERE YOU COULD BUY A HOME FOR
184 TO NOW, WHERE EVEN 750, IN A
LOT OF SENSE, I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE WOULD SAY THAT'S STILL A
LITTLE BIT LOW. BUT THIS AT
LEAST INCREASES THAT AND GIVES
MORE OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE AS
THEY PASS IT DOWN TO THEIR
CHILDREN, TO, TO CREATE THAT
INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH THAT I
THINK SO MANY OF US WANT TO WANT
TO SEE HAPPEN. AND I'LL USE THAT
AS MY CLOSE, IF THAT'S GOOD. AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
. VIÆT. THANK YOU. YES, I MOVE
THE BILL. SENATOR WILK MOVES THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? THANK YOU VERY MUCH, I
RESPECTFULLY. OH, I'M SORRY, I
APOLOGIZE. I WAS TRYING TO
STREAMLINE THE MEETING FOR YOU.
MIND IT. WE'RE ALL ABOUT TIME
HERE. YEAH. ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT,
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION BY SENATOR
WILK. MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FOR ITEM 25, AB 2016. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS. BERG. BERG. I WILK
I WILK. AYE. ALLEN ASHBY.
CABALLERO. DURAZZO. LAIRD NILO.
ROTH. STERN WAHAB. THAT'S 2 TO 0
WITH MEMBERS MISSING. I WILL PUT
THAT ON CALL. ALL RIGHT, SO,
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN FILE NUMBER
26, AB 2159. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS, LET ME START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. AB 2159 AUTHORIZE
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS OR
SIDS, TO USE AN ELECTRONIC
VOTING SYSTEM FOR SPECIFIC
ASSOCIATION BUSINESSES, BOARD
ELECTIONS AND APPROVING
GOVERNING DOCUMENTS. THE
DAVIS-STIRLING ACT, WHICH
GOVERNS SIDS, OUTLINES THE
RIGHTS AND DUTIES OF
ASSOCIATIONS AND THEIR MEMBERS,
INCLUDING THE PROCESS CURRENTLY
CONDUCTED THROUGH A PAPER AND
MAIL BASED SYSTEM SIMILAR TO
CALIFORNIA'S SECRET BALLOT
PROCESS, ELECTRONIC VOTING CAN
ADDRESS VOTER APATHY, WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY A VERY SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE IN CURRENT ASSOCIATION
ELECTIONS, AS MANY ASSOCIATIONS
STRUGGLE TO EVEN OBTAIN A
QUORUM. AB 2159 IS PERMISSIVE,
GIVING ASSOCIATIONS THE OPTION
TO ADOPT ELECTRONIC VOTING. THE
PROCESS WILL BE PART OF THE RULE
ADOPTION PROCESS, WHICH REQUIRES
NOTIFYING MEMBERS BEFORE TAKING
A VOTE AND PROVIDING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS TO
OVERTURN THE BOARD'S DECISION IF
THEY DISAGREE. ASIDE FROM
ALLOWING ELECTRONIC BALLOTS. AB
2159 DOES NOT CHANGE EXISTING
ELECTION PROCEDURES OUTLINED IN
LAW. IT INCLUDES MULTIPLE
NOTIFICATIONS TO MEMBERS ON HOW
TO OPT OUT, INCLUDING IN THE
RULES DURING THE ELECTION
PROCESS AND ANNUALLY THROUGH THE
MEMBER NOTICE. ELECTRONIC VOTING
IN ASSOCIATION ELECTIONS IS
UTILIZED IN 27 DIFFERENT STATES
AND IS A PROVEN TECHNOLOGY. THIS
BILL AIMS TO INCREASE HOMEOWNER
PARTICIPATION WHILE ALSO
REDUCING COSTS. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE AND WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
LEE BROWN, REPRESENTING THE
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, LOUIS
BROWN, HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE. THIS COMMITTEE IS
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE CONCERNS
THAT WE'VE RAISED OVER THE YEARS
WITH VOTER APATHY AND HOA
ELECTIONS. AND SO WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE MR. MAIENSCHEIN
AUTHORING THIS BILL FOR US
TODAY. THERE WAS A SIMILAR BILL
INTRODUCED BACK IN 2013. AND
WHAT YOU CAN SEE IF YOU COMPARE
THE 2013 LEGISLATION TO WHAT WE
HAVE TODAY, ARE THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE LEARNED OVER THOSE YEARS.
127 STATES HAVE ADOPTED THIS
SINCE THAT TIME. WE'VE ALSO
PICKED AND LEARNED FROM THOSE
OTHER STATES TO PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT PROCESSES IN HERE TO
PROTECT INDIVIDUALS, PROTECT
HOMEOWNERS, IN THE ASSEMBLY, WE
ACTUALLY HAD SOME OF THE
ELECTION COMPANIES OPPOSING THIS
BILL. THEY ARE NOW IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL BECAUSE WE'VE WORKED
WITH THEM TO FURTHER DEVELOP THE
PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT THIS
WORKS WITHIN THE EXISTING HOA
ELECTION PROCESS, BUT THEN ALSO
PROVIDES THEM WHAT THEY NEED IN
ORDER TO CONDUCT THESE ELECTIONS
AND AGAIN, PROTECT THE PRIVACY
OF THE HOA MEMBERS, FINALLY, IT
IS PERMISSIVE. THIS IS JUST
AUTHORIZING AN ASSOCIATION TO DO
SO. IF THEY WANT TO ENTER INTO A
CONTRACT WITH AN INSPECTOR OF
ELECTIONS TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN TO
PROVIDE EFFICIENCY, COST
EFFECTIVENESS, AND HOPEFULLY AT
THE END OF THE DAY, INCREASE
VOTER PARTICIPATION WITH THAT
HERE TO ANSWER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS AND ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THOSE IN SUPPORT, MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS, JENNIFER WARD, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COMMUNITY
MANAGERS, THE REALITY IS THAT
VOTER PARTICIPATION IS DISMAL IN
THESE COMMUNITIES, AND THIS BILL
WOULD HELP HELP WITH THAT. SO WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. NOW LET'S TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED, PLEASE EITHER COME TO
THE TABLE OR COME TO THE
MICROPHONE. THANK YOU. CLOSURES
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. IGNACIO
HERNANDEZ, ON BEHALF OF VERIFIED
VOTING, WHICH IS A WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION, IS A NONPROFIT,
NONPARTISAN ORGANIZATION
COMPRISED PRIMARILY OF COMPUTER
SCIENTISTS AND DATA EXPERTS AND
TECHNOLOGY EXPERTS THAT
REGULARLY CONSULT WITH FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS SECRETARY
OF STATE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WE
ARE EXTREMELY CONCERNED WITH
THIS BILL BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH IT
STATES THAT BALLOTS MUST BE
SECRET AND VOTING MUST BE
SECRET, THERE IS NO TECHNOLOGY
THAT HAS BEEN APPROVED FOR USE
IN CALIFORNIA THAT DOES, IN FACT
ENSURE THAT BALLOTS ARE SECRET.
THE TECHNOLOGY HAS NOT BEEN
IDENTIFIED, CONFIRMED OR
CERTIFIED IN CALIFORNIA. SO WHAT
YOU HAVE HERE IS A BILL THAT
SAYS THIS TECHNOLOGY AND THESE
VOTING WILL BE SECRET. BUT THERE
IS NOT THE TECHNOLOGY THAT
EXISTS. THERE'S ALSO NO
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT OF THE
COMPANIES THAT WILL BE OPERATING
THE TECHNOLOGY. THERE'S NO
TESTING OF THE TECHNOLOGY
BEFORE. IT'S USED TO ENSURE THAT
SECRECY IS IN FACT ATTAINABLE.
AND SO UNTIL THAT HAPPENS, WE
HAVE A BILL THAT WILL AUTHORIZE
THE USE OF SOMETHING THAT
DOESN'T EXIST WITHOUT ANY
PRECAUTIONS. SO EVEN IF SOMEBODY
OPTS IN OR DOESN'T OPT OUT,
HOWEVER, IT'S WRITTEN NOW WITH
THE NOTICE, WHICH WE APPRECIATE,
THE ADDITIONAL NOTICE THEY'RE
OPTING INTO A TECHNOLOGY THAT
CANNOT BE GUARANTEED TO PROTECT
THEM. AND KEEP IN MIND, HOAS
HAVE THE POWER. THEY'RE QUASI
GOVERNMENTAL. THEY HAVE THE
POWER TO IMPOSE FINES, IMPOSE
LIENS, AND ALSO INITIATE
FORECLOSURES. AND I BELIEVE WE
HAVE ABOUT 15 MILLION PEOPLE
THAT ARE SUBJECT TO HOA FEES IN
CALIFORNIA. SO IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN FOR US AND
FOR THOSE REASONS, WE'RE OPPOSED
AND HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION, TOM, SIR, WILL BE
PRESENTING TESTIMONY. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIRMAN, AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS TOM, SIR.
I'M A MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE, THE CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION
LAW. I'M A RETIRED SUPERIOR
COURT COMMISSIONER WHO HAS HEARD
MANY HèA CASES ON MY SMALL
CLAIMS CALENDARS SINCE WE
TESTIFIED IN THE ASSEMBLY BY
POINTING OUT HOW THIS BILL
RENDERS JUDICIAL REVIEW OF AN
INTERNET ELECTION IMPOSSIBLE IN
SMALL CLAIMS COURT AMENDMENTS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN IN THE SENATE
HERE. NOW INTRODUCE SOME VERY
ALARMING NEW FEATURES THAT ARE
GUARANTEED TO FLAT OUT DENY SOME
HOMEOWNERS THE ABILITY TO VOTE
AND THEREFORE THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
THIS BILL NOW NO LONGER
GUARANTEES A HOMEOWNER THE RIGHT
TO OPT OUT OF THE ELECTRONIC
VOTING BY DEMANDING A PAPER
BALLOT. THE PROVISION OF THIS
OPT OUT CHOICE IS NOW PERMISSIVE
AND NO LONGER MANDATORY.
SECONDLY IF NOW EXPLICITLY
PROVIDES THAT AN ELECTION MAY BE
CONDUCTED ENTIRELY BY EITHER
PAPER BALLOT OR ELECTRONIC
BALLOT, IT PLACES ON THE
INSPECTOR OF ELECTIONS THE DUTY
TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH A LONG
LIST OF TECHNICAL REQUIREMENTS
FOR ANY ELECTRONIC VOTING SYSTEM
. THIS ENORMOUSLY EXPANDS THE
QUALIFICATIONS NEEDED TO PERFORM
THE INSPECTOR OF ELECTION DUTIES
INTO THE REALM OF CYBER SECURITY
AND AT A LEVEL THAT A PANEL OF
EXPERTS WHO HAS STUDIED THIS
ISSUE FOR OVER A YEAR COULD NOT
ACHIEVE. AND FINALLY, IT
INTRODUCES THE TERM, QUOTE,
ELECTRONIC SECRET BALLOT. BUT
CALLING IT SECRET DOES NOT
RENDER IT SO WHEN THE
OVERWHELMING OPINION OF EXPERTS
IS THAT IT IS IMPOSSIBLE GIVEN
THE CURRENT STATE OF TECHNOLOGY,
TO ENSURE SECRECY OF A BALLOT
THAT IS RETURNED ELECTRONICALLY,
I REFER YOU TO. WELL, ACTUALLY,
HE'S HERE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I ASSUME YOUR VOTE. EXCUSE ME.
STRIKE THAT A NO VOTE, PLEASE.
RIGHT OKAY. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE GIVE US YOUR
NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION. GO AHEAD. YOU CAN
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. MIKE.
RIGHT THERE. SORRY. THE
MICROPHONE RIGHT THERE. MY NAME
IS K¾T WEBER, SACRAMENTO,
CALIFORNIA. VICE CHAIR OF
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED
AMERICANS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. ASHLEY ROSE AND I'M A
HOMEOWNER IN AN HOA AND A FORMER
BOARD MEMBER. AND, HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND I'M VERY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH TAFOYA AND I AM A
SENIOR AND I LIVE IN AN HOA. AND
I URGE THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO.
MR. MURRAY, DID YOU WANT TO
WEIGH IN? YES. SENATOR UMBERG
SPEAKING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED AMERICANS.
ABOUT 2 MILLION SENIORS LIVE IN
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND CARO WEIGHS IN
WITH A NO VOTE PARTY. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION SAYING NO
ONE ELSE APPROACHED THE
MICROPHONE. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE, SENATOR WILK, DO
YOU HAVE A QUESTION? I HAVE A
QUESTION AND A COMMENT, SO I'LL
JUST THROW IT BACK TO YOU TO, TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE CONCERNS
SHARED BY THE OPPOSITION. YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR
WILK. YOU KNOW, FIRST OFF, JUST
TO BRING IT BACK TO WHAT THIS
BILL IS, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOA
ELECTIONS. THAT'S WHAT'S AT
ISSUE HERE. NOT AFRAID OF
HACKING. YEAH, I DON'T THINK
THAT'S A, YOU KNOW, A HIGH RISK
ENVIRONMENT, WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HOA ELECTIONS AND THE
INTENT BEHIND IT IS TO INCREASE
VOTING, YOU KNOW, AND AS A
REMINDER, THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
MADE IT A POLICY TO TRY TO
INCREASE VOTING, WE'VE DONE THAT
ON A WHOLE NUMBER OF THINGS,
INCLUDING, FOR EXAMPLE, MAIL
BALLOTS, SO, YOU KNOW, THAT'S
BEEN A LONG STANDING POLICY. HOW
DO YOU TAKE HOW DO YOU TAKE
SOMETHING WHERE, YOU KNOW, MANY
OF THEM CAN'T EVEN GET A QUORUM?
MANY OF THEM HAVE 1 OR 2 PEOPLE
VOTING 1 OR 2, CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT WOULD NOT BE
REPRESENTATIVE. AND SO THIS WILL
DO THAT. AND I WOULD REMIND
PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, THIS IS
PERMISSIVE, 27 OTHER STATES ARE
DOING IT. SO IT'S NOT NOT A
PARTICULARLY REVOLUTIONARY, AND
THERE'S AN OPT OUT PROVISION
TOO. SO YOU KNOW, I BELIEVE THAT
THAT MORE THAN ADDRESSES THE
ISSUES THAT WE'RE FACED WITH
WITH THIS BILL, WITH THE OPT
OUT. THAT MEANS YOU WOULD GET A
PAPER BALLOT. YEAH. OKAY BECAUSE
I LIVE I HAVE TWO HOAS. ONE,
THERE'S 45 OF US BACK EAST AND
THE OTHER ONE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, THERE'S 5000 HOMES,
HALF OF THEM ARE SNOWBIRDS. AND
SO I'M SURE VOTING
ELECTRONICALLY WOULD BE MUCH
EASIER FOR THEM. BUT IT'S ALSO
SENIOR COMMUNITY, COMMUNITY. I'M
SURE SOME OF THEM ARE NOT
COMFORTABLE DOING THAT. BUT IF
YOU COULD OPT OUT, I THINK THIS
WILL INCREASE VOTER
PARTICIPATION. AND TO, YOU KNOW,
YOU RAISE A GOOD POINT. THERE
TOO. IS YOU KNOW, AS WE AS THIS
PROGRESSES, AS NEWER GENERATIONS
COME ON, WHO ARE MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT DIGITAL
NATIVES COMING UP. CORRECT. YOU
KNOW, AS OUR, YOU KNOW, OUR KIDS
AGE. BUT YEAH, RIGHT. BUT YOUR
KIDS WILL BE VOTING
ELECTRONICALLY. YEAH. THANK YOU.
HOUSE THAT I BOUGHT. RIGHT.
WELL, THE EARLIER BILL WILL HELP
YOU PASS IT DOWN TO THEM, MR.
WILK. SO I'M I'M HERE. I'M HERE
FOR THE WILK FAMILY TODAY. AS
LONG AS THAT APPLIES. HE'S
MOVING TO AMERICA. I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'VE HEARD THAT, BUT, YES,
ALL RIGHT, SO, SENATOR WILK,
I'LL MOVE THE BILL. SENATOR WILK
HAS MOVED THE BILL. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FILE. ITEM NUMBER 26,
AB 2159. THE MOTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED, BERG, A BERG I WILK
WILK. AYE. ALLEN ASHBY.
CABALLERO. DURAZZO. LAIRD NILO.
ROTH. STERNE WAHAB. THAT'S 2 TO
0 MEMBERS MISSING. 2 TO 0. I'M
GOING TO PUT THAT ON CALL. ALL
RIGHT. I THINK I SAW SOME
MURATSUCHI HERE. OH, I DID THERE
HE IS. OKAY, SOME MEMBER
MURATSUCHI FILE NUMBER 23, AB
1825. THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR, AND
SENATORS, I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 1825, THE
CALIFORNIA FREEDOM TO READ ACT.
WE ALL KNOW THAT OUR PUBLIC
LIBRARIES ARE A CORNERSTONE OF
OUR DEMOCRACY. UNFORTUNATELY,
THERE'S BEEN A NATIONWIDE
MOVEMENT TO ATTACK OUR FREEDOM
TO READ, ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN LIBRARY ASSOCIATION,
THERE HAS BEEN OVER 60% INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF ATTEMPTED BOOK
BANS IN OUR PUBLIC LIBRARIES. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT MORE THAN FOUR, 4
TO 7% OF THOSE TITLES BEING
TARGETED ARE PRIMARILY THOSE
REFLECTING THE VOICES AND LIFE
EXPERIENCES OF OUR LGBTQ AND OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THIS IS A
BILL THAT WAS WRITTEN BY
LIBRARIANS AND FIRST AMENDMENT
LAWYERS WITH ME HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE, IS, I'M LOOKING AT MY
NOTES HERE. CHRISTINA DECARO
REPRESENTED THE CALIFORNIA
LIBRARY ASSOCIATION AND CYNTHIA
VALENCIA WITH THE ACLU.
CALIFORNIA. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU.
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. I'M CHRISTINA DECARO,
LOBBYIST FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LIBRARY ASSOCIATION. AND SUPPORT
OF AB 1825. AT THEIR CORE,
LIBRARY DIRECTORS AND STAFF
BELIEVE IN PROTECTING
INTELLECTUAL FREEDOM AND THE
RIGHT OF CALIFORNIA LIBRARY
PATRONS TO HAVE ACCESS TO A
DIVERSE BODY OF MATERIALS THAT
EDUCATE, INSPIRE, INFORM, AND
ENLIGHTEN. LIBRARY PROFESSIONALS
ARE TRAINED IN REVIEWING AND
SECURING MATERIALS THAT SUIT THE
NEEDS OF COMMUNITIES. PUBLIC
LIBRARIES DO NOT SUPPORT THE
BANNING OF BOOKS. WHAT THEY DO
SUPPORT IS HAVING INFORMED
COMMUNITY DISCUSSIONS REGARDING
MATERIALS IN THEIR LIBRARY. MANY
LIBRARIES HAVE POLICIES THAT
ALLOW MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
TO ENGAGE AND RAISE CONCERNS
WITH CERTAIN MATERIALS, AND
HAVING THOSE CLEAR AND DETAILED
POLICIES IN PLACE IN EVERY
PUBLIC LIBRARY IS ESSENTIAL.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE LIBRARIES
TO SUBMIT THOSE POLICIES TO THE
STATE LIBRARIAN, WHO CAN PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IF NEEDED.
CLA WANTS TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND HIS CHIEF
OF STAFF FOR THE PRODUCTIVE
NEGOTIATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN PART
THAT WE HAVE BEEN A PART OF
THROUGHOUT THIS SESSION AND FOR
ACCEPTING THOSE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE VERY IMPORTANT TO CLA. WE
GREATLY APPRECIATED HIS
THOUGHTFUL REGARD OF THE WORK OF
THE LIBRARY COMMUNITY AS HE
CONTINUED TO SHAPE THE BILL AND
I'D LIKE TO TAKE MY FINAL
SECONDS TO THANK THE OUTSTANDING
WORK OF YOUR CONSULTANT, ALLISON
WITT. MEREDITH SHE LOOKED AT THE
BILL WITH SUCH A CAREFUL EYE
MATCHING ITS INTENT TO PASS CASE
LAW AND NOTING WHERE THE
LIBRARIES MIGHT BE LEFT
INADVERTENTLY PROTECTED. SHE
RECOMMENDED ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN YOUR
PACKET THERE THAT WERE THINGS
THAT, FRANKLY, CLA WOULD NOT
HAVE CAUGHT ON OUR OWN. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE EXCELLENT
WORK. AND TO YOU, MR. CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
SPEAKING OF THOSE EXCELLENT
AMENDMENTS, DO YOU ACCEPT THEM?
YES. OKAY. THANK YOU. I CONCUR
IN YOUR THOUGHTS CONCERNING MISS
MEREDITH. ALL RIGHT. GO AHEAD,
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA VALENCIA. I AM A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN SUPPORT OF
AB 1825. THE CALIFORNIA FREEDOM
TO READ ACT. SO PUBLIC LIBRARIES
ARE A CORNERSTONE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES, ENSURING THAT
PEOPLE, REGARDLESS OF AGE,
INCOME, EDUCATION, RACE OR
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION HAVE FREE
AND OPEN ACCESS TO INFORMATION
SO THEY CAN MEANINGFULLY ENGAGE
IN CIVIC LIFE. THEY ARE ALSO
BOUND BY THE FIRST AMENDMENT,
AND WE MUST PROTECT THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT OF ACCESS TO
DIVERSE AND INCLUSIVE
INFORMATION AT OUR PUBLIC
LIBRARY. SO THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI FOR
INTRODUCING THIS LEGISLATION AT
THIS CRITICAL TIME. OVER THE
PAST YEAR, MORE THAN 3000 BOOKS
HAVE BEEN BANNED IN LIBRARIES
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES, AND
THESE BOOKS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY FEATURE
STORIES ABOUT LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE,
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES. BOOK
BANS AT THIS EFFECT ARE NOT ONLY
DISCRIMINATORY, THEY ARE A
VIOLATION OF PEOPLE'S FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT. POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED CENSORSHIP HAS NO
PLACE IN OUR STATE. IN
CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE SEEN SEVERAL
MUNICIPALITIES PASS LEGISLATION
TO CENSOR BOOKS IN FRESNO
COUNTY. THEY INTRODUCED A
RESOLUTION THAT IS AN INVASIVE
AND UNCONSTITUTIONAL FORM OF
CENSORSHIP THAT TARGETS BOOKS
BASED ON SEEMINGLY DISFAVORED
SPEECH, NAMELY, REFERENCES TO
BODILY AUTONOMY AND GENDER
IDENTITY. IN THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH. THEY
INTRODUCED A RESOLUTION WHICH
WOULD IMPOSE AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL
BAN OR AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL
CENSORSHIP REGIME ON PEOPLE'S
RIGHT TO ACCESS LIBRARY BOOKS
AND MATERIALS PROTECTED BY THE
FIRST AMENDMENT. I HAVE BEEN A
RESIDENT OF HUNTINGTON BEACH FOR
OVER 13 YEARS, AND I HAVE BEEN A
PUBLIC LIBRARY USER OF THE
HUNTINGTON BEACH PUBLIC LIBRARY
IN ORANGE COUNTY, PUBLIC LIBRARY
SYSTEM. SINCE I WAS A YOUNG
GIRL, ALL OF US WHO ARE USERS OF
PUBLIC LIBRARIES AND ESPECIALLY
YOUNG PEOPLE, HAVE A RIGHT NOT
JUST TO EXPRESS THEMSELVES, BUT
TO LEARN FROM A DIVERSE RANGE OF
MATERIALS, INCLUDING LIBRARY
BOOKS BY AND ABOUT LGBTQ AND
BIPOC COMMUNITIES. SO WE COMMEND
LIBRARIANS AND COMMUNITIES WHO
HAVE REJECTED THESE CENSORSHIP
CAMPAIGNS. SO WE MUST PROTECT
FUNDAMENTAL FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT OF ACCESS TO DIVERSE AND
INCLUSIVE INFORMATION. FOR THESE
REASONS, WE URGE YOU TO VOTE YES
ON AB 1825. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB 1825, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. GREG
PULSIFER, QUALITY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT, TRACY
ROSENBERG ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND
PRIVACY AND SUPPORT, WE RUN WE
RAN OUT OF TIME TO SUBMIT A
LETTER, BUT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. ETHAN NAGLER, MAYOR OF
THE CITY OF RANCHO CUCAMONGA, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
ONE ELSE COMING FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONE IN SUPPORT, LET'S
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 1825,
PLEASE COME FORWARD SEEING NO
ONE COMING FORWARD, LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS. IS THERE ANY YELLOW.
THE THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. THE
BILL INDICATES, A PROCESS FOR
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO REQUEST
RECONSIDERATION OF MATERIALS
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED,
IS THERE ANY ALLOWANCE FOR,
LOCAL COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO,
SUGGEST, THE ISOLATION OF SOME
MATERIAL? YES. I'D LIKE TO ASK
MISS DECARO TO GIVE THE
LIBRARIAN'S PERSPECTIVE WHERE
THIS BILL IS FOCUSED ON THE
CENTRAL ROLE OF LIBRARIANS. I
DIDN'T HEAR THE FIRST PART OF
WHAT YOU SAID. OH, I WOULD LIKE
TO TURN IT OVER TO MISS DECARO,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LIBRARIANS ASSOCIATION. SO,
SENATOR, YOU'RE ASKING
SPECIFICALLY A AN ITEM THAT
MAYBE SOMEBODY FINDS,
DISTASTEFUL, LIKE TO MOVE IT
INTO A DIFFERENT SECTION? IS
THAT THE QUESTION YOU'RE ASKING?
WELL LET ME BE MORE SPECIFIC.
THE FRUSTRATING THING THAT I'VE
HAD ABOUT THIS DISCUSSION ABOUT
BOOK BANNING IS THAT IT NEVER
EXCEPT WHEN SOME OTHERS BRING IT
UP, INCLUDES A DISCUSSION OF AGE
APPROPRIATENESS. AND I DON'T SEE
ANYTHING IN HERE THAT DEALS WITH
AGE APPROPRIATENESS OR THE
ABILITY TO EXCLUDE A BOOK. NOW,
MAYBE YOU'D CALL THAT BOOK
BANNING, RIGHT? EXCLUDING A BOOK
BASED UPON THE AGE THAT WILL BE
ACCESSING THAT LIBRARY OR THAT
AREA OF THE LIBRARY. AND SO,
PEOPLE, IF THE LIBRARY DOESN'T
CHOOSE TO ACCOMMODATE AGE
APPROPRIATENESS, WHERE IS THE
ABILITY FOR PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY TO SUGGEST THAT THAT
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT FOR EXCLUDING
THE BOOK, WHICH MANY PEOPLE
THESE DAYS IS CALLING BOOK
BANNING? I WOULD SAY BANNING
BOOKS FOR FIVE YEARS OLD. THE
FIVE YEAR OLDS IS NOT BOOK
BANNING, BUT THAT SEEMS TO BE
WHERE THE ARGUMENT HAS BEEN
DOMINATED LATELY. THAT'S MY
WHOLE PROBLEM WITH THIS
LEGISLATION. THROUGH THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. YOU KNOW, WE
ARE UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE IS
QUITE A TREND AFOOT. FOR
REGULATING AGE APPROPRIATE
MATERIALS. WE'RE STARTING TO SEE
THAT MORE AND MORE ON THE
NATIONAL LEVEL. AND SOME OF THE
MONITORING OF THIS, MOST
LIBRARIES DO HAVE DEDICATED
CHILDREN TEENS SECTIONS. NOW IS
IT APPROPRIATE FOR THE PARENTS
TO WALK OVER TO A DIFFERENT
SECTION AND LOOK AT SOME
MATERIALS WITH THEIR CHILDREN,
AS THE ANALYSIS WAS GREAT TO
POINT OUT, THE LIBRARIES DO NOT
STAND IN THE PLACE OF PARENTS
WHEN THE CHILDREN ARE USING THE
LIBRARY. THIS IS SOMETHING THAT,
THAT THAT THEY SHOULD DO
TOGETHER AS A COLLABORATIVE
NATURE, BUT THERE IS THERE DOES
TEND TO BE QUITE A RECOGNITION
THAT THERE SHOULD BE A
CHILDREN'S A-TEENS AND AN OTHER
SECTION, NOT IN EVERY LIBRARY.
CERTAINLY THERE ARE LIBRARIES
THAT DON'T, DON'T SEQUESTER
CERTAIN MATERIALS IN THAT WAY.
BUT, UNDER UNDER THE PROCESS
HERE, YOU COULD FILL OUT A FORM.
I HAVE THE ONTARIO LIBRARIES
POLICY, FOR EXAMPLE. YOU COULD
FILL OUT A FORM AND SAY, I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE A RECONSIDERATION
OF THE PLACEMENT OF THIS ITEM IN
THE LIBRARY. AND THEN THEY WOULD
CONVENE ONE LIBRARY SUPERVISOR
TO BE APPOINTED BY THE LIBRARY
DIRECTOR, WHO ACTS AS A
FACILITATOR TO LIBRARY STAFF
MEMBERS, TO BE SELECTED BY THE
LIBRARY SUPERVISOR. THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ONTARIO CITY
LIBRARY BOARD OF TRUSTEES, THE
VICE PRESIDENT, ETC, AND THIS
REVIEW COMMITTEE WOULD HAVE TO
MEET WITHIN ONE WEEK AFTER
FORMATION TO DETERMINE A PLAN.
AND SO THEN THEY WOULD FORMULATE
THEIR PLAN, BRING IT UP TO THE
LIBRARY DIRECTORS LEVEL. THE
LIBRARY DIRECTOR NEEDED TO GO
HIGHER THAN THAT. THEY COULD GO
HIGHER THAN THAT. SO THERE IS A
AN ATTEMPT FOR A LOCAL. WE WANT
TO FOSTER THOSE DISCUSSIONS. WE
DON'T WANT TO SAY THIS IS THE
RULE OF THE LIBRARY, AND THIS IS
THE WAY IT'S GOING TO BE,
PERIOD. WE WANT THOSE LOCAL
DISCUSSIONS TO OCCUR. THEN WHY
EVEN GET INVOLVED FROM AN ON
HIGH PERSPECTIVE? WHY DON'T WE
JUST LEAVE THIS UP TO LOCAL
CONTROL? SENATOR, IF I MAY, I
WANT TO MAKE IT ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR. IN FACT, YOU KNOW, ONE OF
MY FIRST QUESTIONS WHEN I MET
WITH THE ACLU AND THE AMERICAN
LIBRARY ASSOCIATION WAS, YOU
KNOW, AS A PARENT, YOU KNOW, AM
I GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT BOOKS ARE BEING, DISPLAYED,
NOT NOT ONLY PROVIDED IN THE
LIBRARY, BUT DISPLAYED IN AN AGE
APPROPRIATE MANNER. AND I WAS
ASSURED THAT. ABSOLUTELY,
LIBRARIANS, YOU KNOW, ARE
PROFESSIONALS TRAINED TO MAKE
THOSE DETERMINATIONS RATHER THAN
A POLITICAL BODY THAT THAT MAY,
YOU KNOW, BE RESPONDING TO, YOU
KNOW, THE, THE SENTIMENTS IN THE
COMMUNITY. BUT THIS BILL, YOU
KNOW, SPECIFICALLY, IT IS
ALLOWING FOR THAT LOCAL CONTROL
THAT YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT BY
REQUIRING EVERY PUBLIC LIBRARY
JURISDICTION TO ADOPT A THIS
COLLECTION DEVELOPMENT POLICY
AND THE COLLECTION DEVELOPMENT
POLICY AS, AS YOU CAN SEE IN THE
BILL, ONE OF THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THIS POLICY IS TO ESTABLISH A
PROCESS FOR COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO
SHARE THEIR CONCERNS REGARDING
LIBRARY MATERIALS AND TO REQUEST
LIBRARY MATERIALS BE
RECONSIDERED FOR INCLUSION. THAT
THAT FORMAL PROCESS WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO BE HEARD
ON, YOU KNOW, THE CONSIDERATIONS
OF AGE APPROPRIATENESS STILL
MAKES MORE SENSE TO ME TO LEAVE
THIS UP ENTIRELY TO LOCAL
CONTROL IN ANY CASE, IF I MEAN
THE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PROHIBIT IS, THE, WELL, OF ANY
VOCAL, YOU KNOW, MINORITY OR
MAJORITY OF, OF A COMMUNITY, YOU
KNOW, TO CALL FOR AND BAN BOOK
TITLES THAT DON'T HAVE, YOU
KNOW, THE, THE, THE, THE
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION THAT A
PROFESSIONALLY TRAINED LIBRARIAN
WOULD BE ABLE TO DO. AND SO IT
IS MAINTAINING THE LOCAL
CONTROL. BUT SETTING GUARDRAILS,
MAKING SURE THAT IT'S NOT DONE
IN A DISCRIMINATORY MANNER. AND
IT'S DONE THROUGH THIS, LOCALLY
ADOPTED COLLECTION DEVELOPMENT
POLICY. I THINK, IT'S PROVIDING
FOR THAT LOCAL CONTROL THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR. BUT WITH THE
GUARDRAILS, I'M GETTING A SENSE
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE THE
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL. NOT I
JUST ONE LAST POINT. I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THE VIEWS OF BOTH
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY, AS WELL
AS LIKELY THE LIBRARIAN IS GOING
TO BE QUITE DIFFERENT IN
SUSANVILLE THAN IT'S GOING TO BE
IN SAN FRANCISCO. AND THIS IS
KIND OF PRESCRIBING A BLANKET
APPROACH TO IT. THAT WOULD APPLY
TO BOTH PARTY. THANK YOU, OTHER
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE, IS THERE A MOTION? I DON'T
HEAR A MOTION. THIS IS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. WE'LL RAISE
THIS AGAIN, AND WE'LL SEE IF
THERE'S A MOTION. ALL RIGHT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT, NEXT, WE
TURN TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA.
WITH AMENDMENTS? NO. OKAY ALL
RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS, AB 2780 WILL REQUIRE
CHARTER BUS CARRIERS TO NOTIFY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AT LEAST 24
HOURS BEFORE TRANSPORTING
VULNERABLE PASSENGERS FROM OUT
OF STATE TO A CALIFORNIA CITY,
COUNTY OR OTHER JURISDICTIONS.
SENATORS. SINCE APRIL 2022, WE
HAVE SEEN POLITICAL LEADERS FROM
A NUMBER OF SOUTHERN STATES
ATTEMPT TO POLITICIZE THE
NATION'S CURRENT IMMIGRATION
CRISIS BY BUSSING AND DUMPING
LAWFUL ASYLUM SEEKERS IN CITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THIS IS THE
WORST KIND OF POLITICS
IMAGINABLE. RIGHT WING
POLITICIANS TRAFFICKING
VULNERABLE FAMILIES ACROSS STATE
LINES TO TRY TO SCORE POLITICAL
POINTS WITH MAGA EXTREMISTS.
IT'S DISGUSTING. IT'S SHAMEFUL,
AND IT'S JUST WRONG. THE UNITED
STATES HAS A PROUD HISTORY OF
COMPASSIONATELY WELCOMING LEGAL
ASYLUM ASYLUM SEEKERS FROM
AROUND THE WORLD AND WE SHOULD
NOT FORGET THAT IN THIS
DIFFICULT NATIONAL MOMENT, WE
FIND OURSELVES IN CITIES,
COUNTIES AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE ORGANIZED AS
BEST AS THEY CAN IN THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS TO TRIAGE THESE
LEGAL ASYLUM SEEKERS AND PROVIDE
THEM WITH TEMPORARY HUMANE CARE,
INCLUDING FOOD, CLOTHING AND
SHELTER. WHAT IS MISSING IS
KNOWING WHEN THESE LEGAL ASYLUM
SEEKERS WILL ARRIVE IN
CALIFORNIA CITY, SO THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS CAN HELP PREVENT
POTENTIAL HUMAN LABOR OR SEX
TRAFFICKING. OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS, AND TO BETTER
COORDINATE HUMANITARIAN AID TO
THESE FAMILIES IN NEED. AB 2780
CLOSES AN IMPORTANT GAP BY
REQUIRING CHARTER BUS CARRIERS
TO PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WITH A 24 HOUR NOTICE NEEDED TO
HELP BETTER COORDINATE
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE TO THESE
VULNERABLE FAMILIES. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS CAITLIN
LONNIE, THE DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE, AND
CYNTHIA GÓMEZ, DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF STATE POLICY AND ADVOCACY
WITH THE COALITION FOR HUMAN
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS. THANK YOU.
PARTY. THANK YOU. FIRST WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR LUNDBERG,
VICE CHAIR, WILK AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
CAITLIN LOUGHNEY. I'M DEPUTY
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR HERE ON
BEHALF OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER LARA IS A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF AB 2780
BECAUSE HE BELIEVES IN
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO FIND
SOLUTIONS. CALIFORNIA ALREADY
WELCOMES MORE MIGRANTS AND
ASYLUM SEEKERS THAN ANY OTHER
STATE. THERE IS CURRENTLY A
ROBUST NETWORK OF PUBLIC,
NONPROFIT AND RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS WHO WORK TOGETHER
TO PROVIDE BASIC SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES TO NEWLY ARRIVED
MIGRANTS. WE'RE TALKING WATER,
FOOD, CLOTHING, MEDICAL
SCREENINGS WHEN VULNERABLE
PEOPLE ARRIVE IN CALIFORNIA,
CALIFORNIANS STEP UP. DESPITE
THE EFFORTS OF SOME TO USE
VULNERABLE PEOPLE AS POLITICAL
PAWNS. OUR SIMPLE QUESTION IS
WHAT CAN WE DO TO MAKE THIS
SITUATION BETTER? THE SITUATION
IS THAT CERTAIN OTHER STATES
HAVE CHOSEN TO MOVE THOUSANDS,
POSSIBLY TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
VULNERABLE PEOPLE INTO
CALIFORNIA. INCONSISTENT NOTICE,
AT BEST, IS PROVIDED BY THESE
ACTORS OR BY THE BUS COMPANIES
THAT DISCHARGE VULNERABLE
PASSENGERS AT SEEMINGLY RANDOM
LOCATIONS AT ALL TIMES OF THE
DAY AND NIGHT. SUPPORT SERVICES
THEN SCRAMBLE TO MEET THE BUSSES
BEFORE PASSENGERS ARE RELEASED
ONTO THE STREETS, ENDANGERING
THE PASSENGERS AND OVERWHELMING
LOCAL SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
INSTEAD, AB 2780 WOULD REQUIRE
PRIOR NOTICE OF THE ANTICIPATED
DATE AND TIME OF ARRIVAL, AND
WOULD ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
SET THE LOCATION WHERE THE
BUSSES CAN DROP OFF PASSENGERS
LET US KNOW WHERE AND WHEN, AND
WE WILL DO THE REST. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
THE ABILITY TO WELCOME MIGRANTS
IN A HUMANE MANNER, WITH DIGNITY
AND RESPECT, ALL HUMANS DESERVE.
VIÆT. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA GÓMEZ, DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF STATE POLICY AND ADVOCACY
WITH THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS. CHIRLA CHIRLA
IS PROUD TO CO-SPONSOR AB 2780
AND ARE THANKFUL FOR THE
LEADERSHIP OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCKINNON ON THIS BILL. AS
AFOREMENTIONED, IN RECENT YEARS,
REPUBLICAN CONTROLLED STATES
HAVE SENT NEWLY ARRIVED MIGRANTS
TO DEMOCRATICALLY CONTROLLED
STATES TO ADVANCE HARMFUL
ANTI-IMMIGRANT NARRATIVES IN
PARTICULAR, TEXAS SPENT MORE
THAN $148 MILLION TO CONTRACT
WITH BUS COMPANIES TO SEND
BUSSES OF MIGRANTS TO SANCTUARY
CITIES. AT THE TIME, PRIMARILY
TO CHICAGO AND NEW YORK. CHIRLA
SAW THESE ACTIONS AS INHUMANE,
AND IN ANTICIPATION OF RECEIVING
OUR OWN BUS, ESTABLISHED THE LOS
ANGELES WELCOMES COLLECTIVE,
WHICH IS A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS, FAITH
BASED ORGANIZATIONS, AND THE
CITY AND COUNTY WITH THE GOAL OF
ASSISTING NEWLY ARRIVED
MIGRANTS. IN JUNE 2023, THE LÀ
WELCOMES COLLECTIVE RECEIVED OUR
FIRST BUS FROM TEXAS, AND SINCE
THEN WE HAVE WELCOMED 39 BUSSES,
EACH WITH 40 TO 50 INDIVIDUALS,
INCLUDING INFANTS, SENIORS,
PREGNANT WOMEN, INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES AND FAMILIES. WHEN
WE RECEIVE A BUS IN LOS ANGELES,
WE MOBILIZE TO IDENTIFY A
WELCOME CENTER, COORDINATE FOOD
AND CLOTHING, GATHER VOLUNTEERS,
COORDINATE MEDICAL SCREENINGS,
PRELIMINARY LEGAL AND CASE
MANAGEMENT SUPPORT, AS WELL AS
ASSIST WITH FAMILY REUNIFICATION
. HAVING 24 HOUR ADVANCE NOTICE
ALLOWS US TO ENSURE A WELL
COORDINATED, TRAUMA INFORMED
RESPONSE WITH AND WITHOUT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME. WE
ARE UNABLE TO GUARANTEE THAT
EVERYONE IS ASSISTED PUTTING
MIGRANTS IN VULNERABLE
SITUATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE,
INDIVIDUALS COULD FIND
THEMSELVES UNHOUSED AS MANY DO
NOT HAVE LOS ANGELES AS THEIR
INTENDED DESTINATION. THEY COULD
BECOME VICTIMS OF LABOR ABUSE OR
SCAMS AND IN THE WORST CASES,
BECOME VULNERABLE TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. AB 2780 WOULD
ENSURE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
NONPROFITS HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO
ASSIST MIGRANTS WHO HAVE OFTEN
ENDURED LONG AND DANGEROUS
JOURNEYS AND WOULD CONTINUE TO
SEND A STRONG MESSAGE THAT WE IN
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO
TREAT MIGRANTS WITH WITH THE
HUMANITY THEY DESERVE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION ON THIS
BILL AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
2780, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. ARKHAM ASYLUM WITH
THE MESA VERDE GROUP ON BEHALF
OF IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OTHERS
IN SUPPORT. PLEASE APPROACH
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACH
THOSE OPPOSED TO AB 2780. PLEASE
APPROACH SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHING. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING NO
QUESTIONS. SENATOR, SENATOR
NHIÀU MOVES THE BILL. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE BEAT YOU
TO THE PUNCH, SENATOR WILK. SO
WELL, I'M SO I'VE GOT A
QUESTION. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
KNOW THIS OR NOT BECAUSE YOU
MENTIONED YOU KNOW, IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO IS 24 HOUR
NOTICE. I KNOW THAT THE AND I
DON'T KNOW THE DOLLAR FIGURE
BECAUSE I WASN'T REALLY PLANNING
TO TALK ABOUT THIS, BUT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS FLOWN
IN FROM VENEZUELA AND ALL KINDS
OF OTHER COUNTRIES, TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS TO
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS. DID THEY
GIVE STATES AND CITIES 24 HOUR
NOTICE TO BE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE
THOSE PEOPLE? IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
REALLY. IT PROBABLY IS A GOTCHA
BECAUSE I'M SURE THEY DON'T DO
IT. BUT I'M JUST CURIOUS IF YOU
KNEW IF THEY DID IT, CHAIR.
SENATOR, I'M NOT 1,000% SURE,
BUT I WILL SAY THAT THE GIST OF
THE BILL IS THAT MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE NOTICE, THAT'S THE
IMPORTANT PART. YOU KNOW, WE
CAN'T CONTROL THE ACTIONS OF
OTHERS. BUT WHAT WE REALLY WANT
TO ENSURE IS THAT WHEN THERE ARE
VULNERABLE MIGRANTS EN ROUTE TO
CALIFORNIA, THAT WE HAVE A
SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF TIME TO SET
UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
NEEDED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE YOU
KNOW, ADDRESS THEIR IMMEDIATE
NEEDS. BECAUSE, LIKE I HAD
MENTIONED, FOLKS HAVE JUST
ENDURED A LONG JOURNEY. THEY'RE
ASYLUM SEEKERS, SO THEY'RE, YOU
KNOW, IN FEAR OF THEIR LIVES.
AND SO WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE PROPER AMOUNT
OF TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
MEET THEIR THEIR NEEDS. OKAY.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
SEEING NONE, SENATOR NIELLO HAS
MOVED THE BILL. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? YES. WE JUST REALLY
JUST AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID, WE
JUST REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHEN, WHEN, WHEN THESE
FOLKS LAND IN CALIFORNIA, THAT
THEY'RE TAKING CARE OF IN A
HUMANE WAY, WE'RE ASKING JUST
FOR THE 24 HOURS. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR NIELLO. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER 24, AB 2780. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED. THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG UMBERG.
AYE. WILK ALLEN. ASHBY.
CABALLERO. DURAZO LAIRD. NIELLO.
NIELLO. AYE ROTH. STERN. WAHAB.
2 TO 0, 2 TO 0. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
PUT THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. I SEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW
HERE. THANK YOU. MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY, FOR PROVIDING A
CONSTANT STREAM OF AUTHORS HERE.
WE THOUGHT WE MIGHT HAVE A
BREAK, BUT YOU GUYS FOOLED US,
SO THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ACCOMMODATIONS, MR.
CHAIR. YOU HAVE ITEM NUMBER 29
AB 2132. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2132 TO
HELP ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF RISING
TUBERCULOSIS AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE INCREASING
ASSESSMENT AND SCREENING. AND
THIS BILL HELPS TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE TACKLED THIS ISSUE WITH
ADDITIONAL DETECTION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AND HAVE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AS WELL. THANK YOU.
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS PRIYANKA
MANGANI AND I'M A PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL AND EPIDEMIOLOGIST.
HAVING WORKED ON TB AS WELL AS
HIV CONTROL ACROSS INDIA, AFRICA
AND ON USAID AND CDC FUNDED
PROJECTS. I'M ALSO A
TUBERCULOSIS SURVIVOR AND I WISH
TO LEVERAGE MY PERSONAL JOURNEY
AND EXPERTISE TO PIONEER
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS, AIMING TO
ERADICATE THE BURDEN OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASES AND
TRANSFORMS LIVES. IF WE WERE TO
EXCLUDE COVID 19 DATA, TB IS THE
DEADLIEST INFECTIOUS DISEASE
WORLDWIDE AND KILLS SOMEONE
EVERY SECONDS. THE UNITED STATES
HAS SEEN AN INCREASE IN TB CASES
AND AS OF MARCH 2024, AN
ESTIMATED 13 MILLION PEOPLE IN
THE UNITED STATES HAVE LATENT
TB, A CONDITION WHERE THE
BACTERIA CAN HARBOR ITSELF IN A
PATIENT'S BODY FOR DECADES. SUCH
AS 20 TO 30 YEARS, WITHOUT ANY
SYMPTOMS, WHICH LEADS TO MANY
PEOPLE NOT KNOWING THAT THEY
HAVE AN INFECTION UNTIL IT'S TOO
LATE. CALIFORNIANS ARE
PARTICULARLY IMPACTED BY TB, AND
WE ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED SINCE WE HAVE DOUBLE
THE RATE AS COMPARED TO THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE. AND ESTIMATED
2 MILLION CALIFORNIANS ARE
INFECTED WITH TB, OF WHICH ONLY
23% ARE AWARE OF THEIR INFECTION
AND ONLY 13% HAVE BEEN TREATED.
TB IS KNOWN TO KILL MORE THAN
200 CALIFORNIANS EACH YEAR, AND
WE SEE A HIGH BURDEN AMONGST
AMERICAN, ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS, LATINO, BLACK AND
HOMELESS POPULATION, AS WELL AS
THOSE WITH CO-INFECTIONS SUCH AS
DIABETES, END STAGE RENAL
DISEASE, HIV INFECTION AND
HEPATITIS C. AS A TB SURVIVOR, I
CANNOT STRESS ENOUGH THE
IMPORTANCE OF TESTING AND TIMELY
TREATMENT. I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
ACTIVE TUBERCULOSIS AND
INITIALLY HAD NO SYMPTOMS
BESIDES WEIGHT LOSS AND CHEST
PAIN, WHICH LED TO A COMPLICATED
DIAGNOSIS. SINCE I HAD NO
PRODUCTIVE COUGH OR EVEN A
SPUTUM TEST, I WAS FINALLY
DIAGNOSED ON THE BASIS OF A CT
SCAN, WHICH SHOWED ACTIVE TB
INFECTION POST, TO WHICH I
COMPLETED MY ENTIRE TREATMENT
AND WAS DECLARED TB FREE. AFTER
NINE MONTHS OF DAILY ADHERENCE
TO MY MEDICATIONS. I WOULD LIKE
TO STRESS THAT PROMOTING TB
SCREENING AND EARLY TREATMENT
CAN PREVENT FURTHER TRANSMISSION
OF THE DISEASE, RELAPSE AND POOR
TREATMENT OUTCOMES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. PROBABLY
NEED TO TURN THE MICROPHONE TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK IN THIS SPACE. I ASSUME YOU
URGE AND I VOTE. THANK YOU.
OKAY, GREAT. THANKS OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH WITH
NIELSEN MERKSAMER ON BEHALF OF
THE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. KELLY BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ISABELLA ARGUETA WITH THE
HEALTH OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. OTHERS IN SUPPORT. PLEASE
APPROACH. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING, LET'S TURN NOW TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 2132, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE SEEING
NO ONE MOVING ABOUT. ALL RIGHT.
I MOVE THE BILL. SENATOR WILK
HAS MOVED THE BILL. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SEEING NONE. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I ASK FOR OUR
VOTE. YOU ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM SECRETARY. IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR WILK. THIS IS FINAL
ITEM. DID HE CLOSE? OH, I'M
SORRY YOU ASKED. YOU CLOSED.
RIGHT? OKAY HE DID ASK. AND HE
SAID RESPECTFULLY. SO WE GOT TO
MOVE AHEAD. OKAY. SO FILE ITEM
29 AB 2132. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
UMBERG Ã UMBERG. AYE. WILK.
AYE. WILK. AYE. ALLEN ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. CABALLERO GRASSO.
LAIRD. NHIÀU NEAL. AYE. ROTH.
STERNE WAHAB. 4 TO 0. EXCUSE ME.
FOUR ZERO. WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW. YOU HAVE
ITEM NUMBER 31 AB 2421. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. JUST ASSEMBLY AS
EXPEDITIOUS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2421 TO HELP
CONTINUALLY FOSTER TRUST AND
EFFECTIVE REPRESENTATION. WITH
ME TODAY, I HAVE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. WELL DONE. ALL RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS TIM
TALBOT. I'M AN ATTORNEY FOR
PORAC, WHO IS A SPONSOR OF THE
BILL TO ENSURE PUBLIC SECTOR
LABOR UNIONS FUNCTION AS
GUARANTEED BY CALIFORNIA'S
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING LAWS.
UNION EMPLOYEES MUST BE ASSURED
THAT WHAT THEY TELL THEIR UNION
REPRESENTATIVES IN CONFIDENCE
CANNOT BE FORCED OUT OF THEM BY
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
GOVERNMENT OR THEIR AGENTS.
COERCIVE EMPLOYER QUESTIONING OF
A UNION REPRESENTATIVE WHOSE
ONLY ROLE IN A MATTER AROSE FROM
THEIR STATUS AS A REPRESENTATIVE
SERVES NO PURPOSE EXCEPT TO FISH
FOR UNION STRATEGIES,
INCRIMINATING INFORMATION, AND
POTENTIAL ADMISSIONS OF
WRONGDOING BY EMPLOYEES. AB 2421
IS A LABOR RELATIONS BILL THAT
ALIGNS WITH EXISTING PRECEDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD,
WHICH HOLDS THAT COERCIVE
QUESTIONING OF EMPLOYEES AND THE
UNION REPRESENTATIVES ABOUT
CONFIDENTIAL UNION MATTERS
UNLAWFULLY INTERFERES WITH THE
REPRESENTATION AND IS AN UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICE. AB 2421 WILL NOT
HAMPER EMPLOYER WORKPLACE
INVESTIGATIONS AS CLAIMED BY
OPPONENTS. PUBLIC EMPLOYERS AND
THEIR AGENTS RETAIN THE ABILITY
TO ORDER EMPLOYEES AND COWORKERS
WHO SERVE AS EMPLOYEE
REPRESENTATIVES TO DISCLOSE WHAT
THEY PERSONALLY OBSERVED IN THE
WORKPLACE AND WITH RESPECT TO
ANY OTHER MATTER THAT'S NOT
PROTECTED AS WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
THE REPRESENTATION. AND WHEN AN
EMPLOYER REPRESENTATIVE IS A
WITNESS OR INVOLVED IN THE SAME
MATTER UNDER INVESTIGATION, AB
2421 MAKES CLEAR THAT
CONFIDENTIALITY DOES NOT APPLY
TO THEIR COMMUNICATIONS. WHILE
AB 2421 WOULD APPLY TO EMPLOYER
QUESTIONING DURING LITIGATION,
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEEDINGS,
INCLUDING DEPOSITIONS PURSUANT
TO EXISTING PERB PRECEDENT, A
BALANCING TEST IS USED TO WEIGH
THE EMPLOYER'S INTEREST IN
INQUIRING THE ACQUIRING THE
INFORMATION AGAINST THE ADVERSE
IMPACT ON COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
RIGHTS, AND AS NOTED IN THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS, THIRD
PARTIES AND COURTS ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL. IMPORTANTLY, THE TERM
EMPLOYEE REPRESENTATIVE IS USED
IN AB 2421 DOES NOT MEAN ANY
COWORKER, BUT REFERS TO AN
OFFICER, REPRESENTATIVE, OR
AUTHORIZED AGENT OF THE UNION
BASED ON EXISTING PRECEDENT. THE
OPPONENTS CONCERNS ABOUT SB 2421
HAVE BEEN SUFFICIENTLY
ADDRESSED, AND THE BILL PROPERLY
BALANCES THE INTERESTS OF
EMPLOYEES, EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE PUBLIC
SECTOR. EMPLOYERS MR. CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS RANDY PERRY WITH AARON
REED AND ASSOCIATES, ON BEHALF
OF PORAC AND THE OTHER
CO-SPONSORS, CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HIGHWAY PATROL,
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS. OKAY,
I'M TRYING NOT TO LOOK AT MY
NOTES. CAL FIRE FIREFIGHTERS IN
THE UNITED AUTO WORKERS ARE
PERMITTED TO LOOK AT NOTES. I
KNOW WHAT I WAS TRYING TO DO
WITHOUT, ALL IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS. KOBE
PRESIDING WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, SHANE GUSMAN, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND THE
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT PARTY.
THANK YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING
THOSE OPPOSED TO AB 2421, PLEASE
EITHER APPROACH THE TABLE, GO
AHEAD AND SIT DOWN AND OR THE
MICROPHONE. ALL RIGHT. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO GO FIRST? GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. MY NAME IS
AARON AVERY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO AB 2421.
ALTHOUGH THE BILL SPONSORS HAVE
INDICATED THAT THEY SEEK TO
CODIFY PERB DECISIONS, THE
BILL'S RESTRICTIONS GO BEYOND
THE PERB DECISION CITED IN THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS, AND THE
NEED FOR THIS LEGISLATION IN
THIS SPACE HAS NOT BEEN
ESTABLISHED. WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS MADE TO THE
BILL, BUT THEY DO NOT RESOLVE
OUR CONCERNS FOR TWO PRIMARY
REASONS. FIRST, PRIOR TO THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS, THE BILL'S
INTENT LANGUAGE STATED THAT THE
BILL WAS INTENDED TO CREATE A
PRIVILEGE. WHILE THAT INTENT
LANGUAGE HAS BEEN REVERSED, THE
BILL'S SUBSTANTIVE PROVISIONS
REMAIN THE SAME OR LARGELY
UNCHANGED BY PREVENTING EMPLOYER
QUESTIONING OF CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS WITH POTENTIALLY
RELEVANT INFORMATION. THIS BILL
WILL STILL HAVE THE SAME EFFECT
AS A PRIVILEGE IN SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES. HOWEVER, UNLIKE
PRIVILEGES SUCH AS ATTORNEY
CLIENT PRIVILEGE OR PHYSICIAN
PATIENT, THIS BILL HAS NONE OF
THE PROTECTIONS SET FORTH IN THE
EVIDENCE CODE THAT THAT PERTAIN
TO THOSE TYPES OF PRIVILEGES.
SECOND, REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THE BILL'S PROVISIONS ARE
CHARACTERIZED AS A PRIVILEGE,
THEY WILL INTERFERE WITH
EMPLOYER INVESTIGATIONS WHERE
RELEVANT INFORMATION HAS BEEN
SHARED BETWEEN AN EMPLOYEE AND
EMPLOYEE REPRESENTATIVE. THIS
WILL LIMIT THE ABILITY OF PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS TO CONDUCT
INVESTIGATIONS INTO WORKPLACE
SAFETY, HARASSMENT AND OTHER
ALLEGATIONS AS REQUIRED BY LAW,
INCLUDING UNDER LAST YEAR'S SB
53 BY SENATOR CORTEZ. THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL TO CREATE
AN EXCLUSION FOR CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE AN EMPLOYEE REPRESENTATIVE
IS A PARTY OR WITNESS, ARE
EXCEPTIONALLY NARROW AND ARE
LIMITED TO THAT REPRESENTATIVE
SPECIFICALLY BEING A PARTY OR
WITNESS TO EVENTS FORMING THE
BASIS OF A POTENTIAL
ADMINISTRATIVE DISCIPLINARY
PROCEEDING OR A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION, LEAVING OTHER
PROCEEDINGS NOT COVERED BY THE
BILL, INCLUDING LITIGATION.
FINALLY, THE BILL LEAVES
IMPORTANT TERMS UNDEFINED,
LEADING TO POTENTIAL DISPUTES.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MISS HOFFMAN. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS
ASHLEY HOFFMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED THE
ANALYSIS. NOTES THE CONCEPT OF
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN EMPLOYEE AND UNION
REPRESENTATIVE IS NOT ENTIRELY
NEW, AND AS THE PROVISIONS HAVE
INDICATED, PERB AND THE NLRB
HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR THAT
COERCIVE QUESTIONING THAT LEADS
TO AN INTERFERENCE WITH A
WORKER'S RIGHT TO ORGANIZE IS
NOT PERMITTED, AND PERB
THEREFORE, HAS ARTICULATED
BALANCING TEST TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THE EMPLOYER'S
QUESTIONING WAS UNLAWFUL
INTERFERENCE. PERB, FOR EXAMPLE,
LOOKS AT THE SCOPE OF THE
QUESTIONING, ITS PURPOSE,
WHETHER THE INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE THROUGH OTHER AVENUES,
AND THE EMPLOYER'S INTERESTS AS
COMPARED TO THE EMPLOYEES
INTERESTS. THIS BALANCING TEST
RECOGNIZES THAT THERE ARE OFTEN
COMPETING INTERESTS AND THAT A
BALANCING TEST IS THEREFORE
APPROPRIATE. OUR CONCERN IS THAT
AB 2421 EFFECTIVELY SAYS THAT
OUTSIDE OF THE TWO VERY NARROW
EXCEPTIONS, THERE IS NEVER AN
INTEREST OF THE EMPLOYER TO
JUSTIFY ANY QUESTIONS WHATSOEVER
ABOUT CERTAIN COMMUNICATIONS.
THIS SEEMS TO BE AT ODDS WITH
EXISTING LAW AND EMPLOYER'S
OBLIGATIONS TO MAINTAIN SAFE
WORKPLACES THAT ARE FREE FROM
MISCONDUCT OR UNLAWFUL BEHAVIOR,
AS WELL AS THE FACT THAT IT
APPEARS ARBITRARY THAT, FOR
EXAMPLE, DURING A LITIGATION
PROCEEDING, A NON EMPLOYER,
DEFENDANT OR OTHER PARTY COULD
ASK QUESTIONS, BUT THE EMPLOYER
DEFENDANT WOULD BE THE ONLY ONE
PROHIBITED FROM DOING SO. FOR
THOSE REASONS, WE URGE A NO VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OTHERS WHO ARE OPPOSED.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHRIS REIF ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION, IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ETHAN
NAGLER I HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RECREATION AND
PARK DISTRICTS IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. DOROTHY JOHNSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS. ALSO, MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA, RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA, CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES, PRISM, AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA ALL EXPRESSING
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, ERIC LARA
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
JOHNNY PINA WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AFTERNOON, JAMIE HUFF WITH
THE CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
THANKS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. OTHERS OPPOSED. PLEASE
APPROACH SEEING NOBODY ELSE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
. QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I HAVE SOME NO ONE ELSE HAS
SOME. ALL RIGHT, I'LL GO ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. SINCE I'M
CHAIR OF JUDICIARY, I'LL PLAY
CHAIR JUDICIARY FOR JUST A
MOMENT. IN TERMS OF THE UNION
REPRESENTATIVE, WHERE DOES THEIR
DUTY OF LOYALTY LIE TO THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO COMMUNICATES
CERTAIN THINGS OR TO THE
ORGANIZATION? AND WHEN YOU SAY
DUTY OF OR THE ORGANIZATION, DO
YOU MEAN AS A LAWYER OR THE
UNION? NÓ, FOR EXAMPLE, A LAWYER
HAS A DUTY OF LOYALTY, SO THE
UNION REPRESENTATIVE, I'LL JUST
USE THAT AS AN ANALOGY. IT MAY
NOT BE A PERFECT ANALOGY, BUT AS
TO THE UNION REPRESENTATIVE, TO
WHOM DOES THE UNION
REPRESENTATIVE OWE A DUTY OF
LOYALTY, IF ANY, EITHER TO AN
INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYEE OR TO THE
UNION? GENERALLY, MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THEY OWE THEIR
DUTY TO THE UNION ITSELF, AND
THEN THEY ARE TASKED WITH
REPRESENTING INDIVIDUAL
EMPLOYEES ON BEHALF OF THE
UNION. SO IN TERMS OF THEIR,
DUTY OF CONFIDENTIALITY, IF ONE
EMPLOYER REVEALS THE UNION
REPRESENTATIVE, THAT THAT THAT
EMPLOYEE INTENDS TO HARM OTHER
UNION EMPLOYEES, WHAT IS THE
UNION REPRESENTATIVES
RESPONSIBILITY? SO THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE LAW THAT
PRECLUDES AN EMPLOYEE FROM
DISCLOSING WHAT THEY MAY HAVE
SHARED WITH THE UNION
REPRESENTATIVE. HOWEVER, THE
UNION REPRESENTATIVE WOULD BE
PRECLUDED FROM DISCLOSING
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS THAT
FALL WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
REPRESENTATION. SO THE EMPLOYERS
ARE FREE TO ASK ANY PERCIPIENT
WITNESS. I MAYBE I DIDN'T ASK A
QUESTION. CLEARLY, NO UNION
EMPLOYEE GOES TO THEIR UNION
REPRESENTATIVE AND SAYS I INTEND
TO HARM OTHER EMPLOYEES IN MY
WORKPLACE. THE REPRESENTATIVE,
THE UNION REPRESENTATIVE TO WHOM
THAT COMMUNICATION WAS DELIVERED
. DOES THAT UNION REPRESENTATIVE
HAVE ANY DUTY OR PROHIBITION ON
COMMUNICATING THAT INFORMATION?
SO YOU'VE PROBABLY TOUCHED ON
ONE OF THE MOST DIFFICULT
QUESTIONS, IN MY EXPERIENCE,
THAT UNION REPRESENTATIVES HAVE
TO DEAL WITH. AND UNDER THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THE SAFETY
OF AN INDIVIDUAL IS PARAMOUNT
AND IT APPEARS THAT IT'S, YOU
KNOW, CREDIBLE, THEN, I THINK
INDIVIDUALS HAVE TO TAKE THE
SAFETY OF THEMSELVES AND
EVERYONE IN THE WORKPLACE AND
ELEVATE THAT ABOVE,
CONFIDENTIALITY AND THOSE KINDS
OF CIRCUMSTANCES. THAT WOULD BE
AN EXCEPTION. AND THERE ARE
EXCEPTIONS TO CONFIDENTIALITY.
IT IS NOT AS STRICT AS A
PRIVILEGE. BUT WOULD IT BE
REQUIRED OR WOULD IT SIMPLY THE
PROHIBITION BE REMOVED? IN OTHER
WORDS, WOULD THE UNION
REPRESENTATIVE AT THAT POINT BE
REQUIRED TO COMMUNICATE THAT? I
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT ABSENT A WORKPLACE
POLICY. AND SO WE'RE WE'RE
TALKING A LOT ABOUT THE
ENACTMENT OF NEW POLICIES SINCE
JULY 1ST, WHERE THOSE KINDS OF
REPORTING ARE MANDATED. AND I DO
THINK THAT THE DUTY OF AN
EMPLOYEE TO MAINTAIN A SAFE
WORKPLACE WOULD PROBABLY TRUMP
SOME OF THOSE OTHER TYPES OF
CONSIDERATIONS AND HOW THEY GO
ABOUT DISCLOSING THAT THERE
MIGHT BE SOME NEED FOR SOME, YOU
KNOW, DELICACY IN TERMS OF
HANDLING THAT, I WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE DON'T GET OUR TERMS
CROSSED HERE. I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE EMPLOYEE. I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE UNION REPRESENTATIVE.
I AM WELL, SAYING THE UNION
REPRESENTATIVE THEN WOULD HAVE A
DUTY TO REPORT OR NÓ. WELL, SO
MAYBE THERE'S WHERE THE
CONFUSION LIES. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT EMPLOYEES WHO SERVE AS
UNION REPRESENTATIVES. THEIR
EMPLOYER IS A PUBLIC AGENCY.
THEY MAY. EMPLOY AS A EMPLOYEE
OF THE UNION. THE UNION MAY HAVE
A SEPARATE NON-STATE,
REPRESENTATIVE. NONE OF YOU
KNOW, THE EMPLOYER HAS NO
CONTROL OVER THEM. WE'RE ONLY
TALKING ABOUT SHOP STEWARDS,
PEOPLE WHO ARE EMPLOYEES IN THE
WORKPLACE, WHO SERVE AS STEWARDS
TO REPRESENT OTHER INDIVIDUALS
AND BECOME WITNESSES TO CONDUCT
IN THE WORKPLACE. I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT WHAT THEY'VE
OBSERVED, SMELT HEARD. I'M
TALKING ABOUT WHAT WAS
COMMUNICATED TO THEM IN
CONFIDENCE BY ANOTHER EMPLOYEE.
YEAH, THAT IS THE MOST DIFFICULT
SCENARIO, RIGHT? BECAUSE IF THAT
PERSON CAME AND JUST TOLD THEM
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO THAT,
BUT WASN'T SEEKING ADVICE OR
SOMETHING, I THINK THAT'S CLEAR.
THERE'S NO CONFIDENTIALITY
PROTECTING THAT COMMUNICATION.
IF IT GOES FURTHER ABOUT WHAT I
SHOULD DO OR NOT DO, THEN I
THINK IT'S INCUMBENT UPON THAT
REPRESENTATIVE TO GIVE PROPER
DIRECTION UNDER THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL, CAN IT CAN THE
UNION REPRESENTATIVE I RECOGNIZE
OR THE STEWARD WHO'S BEEN
DISCLOSED CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION? CAN THEY BE
SUBPOENAED? CAN THEY BE REQUIRED
TO DISCLOSE IT BY, FOR EXAMPLE,
A COURT ORDER? YEAH. THE BILL
DOES NOT APPLY TO A COURT. SO
AGAIN, A COURT AND WHAT WE THINK
IS THAT THE BALANCING TEST THAT
WAS MENTIONED WOULD BE RELEVANT
IN A COURT'S ANALYSIS OF
DISCLOSING THAT INFORMATION. BUT
IT DOESN'T RISE TO THE SAME
LEVEL AS A PRIVILEGE. SO THE
COURT WOULD BE REQUIRED BY THIS
BILL TO GO THROUGH THAT ANALYSIS
BEFORE THEY WOULD COMPEL SOMEONE
TO. IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T SPEAK
TO THE COURT HAVING TO DO THAT.
RIGHT. THIS IS A PROHIBITION ON
EMPLOYER QUESTIONING. SO THE
EMPLOYER WOULD BE COMING FORWARD
SAYING, I NEED THIS INFORMATION.
THE RELEVANT INQUIRY IS CAN YOU
OBTAIN IT THROUGH ANY OTHER
MEANS THAT DO NOT INVADE THE
PROVINCE OF THE CONFIDENTIALITY?
AND IF SO, YOU SHOULD AVAIL
YOURSELF TO THOSE? IF NOT, THEN
YEAH, I THINK THE COURT COULD
SAY SOMETHING. ALL RIGHT. WELL
WE HAVE CONFLICTING WE HAVE
ISSUES THAT THAT BUMP AGAINST
ONE ANOTHER. IT'S WORKPLACE
SAFETY CONFIDENTIALITY BEING
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE IN
CONFIDENCE. SO ALL RIGHT ENOUGH
OF THAT. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. IS THERE A MOTION
SENATOR BARRASSO MOVES THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY SENATOR
BARRASSO MOVED THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT. AND I THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOWE CLOSED. DID YOU
CLOSE? OH, YEAH. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. GREAT. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM 31 AB24 21.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS, BERG, I WILK I
WILK I ALLEN ASHBY. ASHBY I
CABALLERO. DURAZZO. DURAZZO I
LAIRD. NHIÀU ROTH. STERN. WAHAB.
4 TO 0 FOUR ZERO. PUT THAT ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. I
ONLY SEE ONE ASSEMBLY PERSON
HERE. AND I THINK THAT'S
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY. SO WE'LL
WAIT A WHILE TILL SOMEONE ELSE
SHOWS UP, NO. GO AHEAD. RIGHT,
RIGHT. YOU HAVE TO BE QUICK. YOU
WERE QUICK. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HERE WE GO. ALL
RIGHT. WHICH 1 A.M. I DOING? I
GOT THREE, WELL, LET'S START
WITH FILE NUMBER 43, AB 2374.
ALL RIGHT. 23, 74. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, AB 2374
WILL STRENGTHEN CALIFORNIA'S
DISPLACED JANITORS OPPORTUNITY
ACT BY EXPANDING PROTECTIONS FOR
LAID OFF JANITORS. IN 2002,
CALIFORNIA PASSED THE DISPLACED
JANITORS OPPORTUNITY ACT TO
PREVENT MASS LAYOFFS OF
JANITORS. WHEN THERE'S A CHANGE
IN THE STAFFING AGENCY AT THE
SAME FACILITY, IF A JANITORIAL
SERVICES CONTRACT IS TERMINATED,
THE ACT CURRENTLY ALLOWS THE
LAID OFF JANITORS TO CONTINUE
WORKING IN THE SAME POSITION
UNDER THE NEW JANITORIAL
STAFFING AGENCY FOR 60 DAYS.
HOWEVER, THERE IS NO LONGER
ADEQUATE TIME FOR LAID OFF
WORKERS TO TRANSITION BETWEEN
JOBS AND THE RECENT MASS LAYOFFS
ACROSS ALL INDUSTRIES HAVE
EXPOSED OTHER SHORTCOMINGS IN
THE EXISTING ACT. FOR EXAMPLE,
ON DECEMBER 5TH, 2022, X,
FORMERLY KNOWN AS TWITTER, ENDED
ITS 12 YEAR CONTRACT WITH A
JANITORIAL AGENCY. THIS DECISION
LEFT THOSE JANITORS WITHOUT A
JOB OVERNIGHT. RIGHT BEFORE THE
HOLIDAYS, X WAS ABLE TO EXPLOIT
THE LOOPHOLES IN THE CURRENT LAW
TO NOT PROVIDE THE ADEQUATE
TRANSITIONAL EMPLOYMENT PERIOD
TO THE LAID OFF JANITORS. THIS
BILL WILL UPDATE THE CALIFORNIA
DISPLACED JANITORS OPPORTUNITY
ACT, CLOSING THESE LOOPHOLES AND
REQUIRING ADEQUATE NOTIFICATION
TO JANITORS WHO HAVE BEEN LAID
OFF. WE WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND HAVE AMENDED THE
BILL TO ADDRESS NEARLY ALL OF
THEIR CONCERNS, PARTICULARLY
THOSE THAT HAD LED TO GREATER
OPPOSITION TO START OUT WITH AND
WITH ME TO TESTIFY HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I HAVE
ROMNEY SIGN AND JULIO ALVARADO
FROM SEIU LOCAL 87 WELCOME. YOU
EACH GET TWO MINUTES WHENEVER
YOU'RE COMFORTABLE. SORRY. TODOS
LOS JANITORS DE LOCAL. NO
SOLAMENTE EL JANITORS DE LOCAL.
TODOS LOS TRABAJADORES DE
LIMPIEZA POR PARTE DE
CALIFORNIA. UNA DE LAS PARTES
QUÊ NOSOTROS ESTAMOS A PIDIENDO
LES DE FAVOR QUÊ A. QUÊ APOYAN A
LA LEGISLACIÓN QUÊ YA EXIST LA
Ã 2370. CUATRO ES PORQUE LAS
COMPANIAS DE LIMPIEZA ESTAN
BENEFICIADO DE C¯. GRACIAS
DESAFORTUNADAMENTE A LO C¯ HIZO
EL NUEVO DUENO DE TWITTER ABRIO
LA PUERTA QUÊ LAS COMPANIAS
ESTAN APROVECHANDO DE TODOS LOS
BENEFICIOS QUÊ. TENEMOS AHORITA
NOSOTROS. LOS JANITORS, THE
LOCAL IN SAN FRANCISCO,
CALIFORNIA. HI I'M GOING TO. HI.
MY NAME IS MARIELLA. I'M GOING
TO TRANSLATE FOR HIM, HIS NAME
IS JULIO. HE'S A MEMBER OF THE
SEIU LOCAL 87. HE WAS ONE OF THE
MEMBERS AFFECTED WHEN TWITTER
SHUT DOWN, HE FEELS THAT, WHEN
THE NEW OWNER TOOK OVER, THAT
KIND OF, LIKE, OPEN UP THE DOORS
FOR OUR MEMBERS TO HAVE, LIKE,
UNFAIR LABOR, THEY WERE THEY
LOST BUSINESSES, THE LOST FAMILY
MEMBERS. AND IT'S UP TO THE
DATE. THEY HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
RECUPERATE FROM THAT LOSS. SO
THEY'RE REALLY HERE TO ASK IF,
YOU KNOW, THIS BILL, CAN PASS,
BECAUSE THAT'S GOING TO HELP ALL
OF OUR 5000 MEMBERS THAT THERE
ACTUALLY BELONG TO LOCAL 87.
THEY HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY THIS
TRAGEDY THAT HAPPENED WHEN
TWITTER SHUT DOWN. ME GUSTARIA
C¯, POR FAVOR A ESCUCHAR UNO DE
NUESTROS HERMANOS C¯ TAMBIÉN FUE
PARTE DE LICCARDO DE TWITTER.
QUÊ FUE UNO DE LOS AFECTADOS.
QUÉ ES PAPA Y PADRE DE FAMILIA
DE CADA UNO DE LOS PADRES DE
FAMILIA? QUÊ TRABAJAN ES UN
PARTIDO DE NOSOTROS DEPENDEMOS
CADA UNO DE LOS CHICOS QUÊ NOS
DAN Ã ME GUSTARIA QUÊ ESCUCHAR
EN SU VERSION. MARTIN MARTIN SE
PUEDE PASAR POR. HE WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE ONE OF OUR MEMBERS.
MARTIN, GIVE OUT HIS TESTIMONY.
HE'S A FATHER, ALSO LOST A JOB.
YOU ONLY HAVE TO. ARE YOU
TESTIFYING? OR WE CAN HAVE HIM
TESTIFY. IT'S OKAY. IT'S MORE
IMPORTANT THAN MINE. LAWCENTER
MARTIN. BIENVENIDOS TARDES. GOOD
AFTERNOON. BUENOS TARDES. MY
NAME IS MARTIN FRANCISCO SADA
GUIDO. BÀN. VENGO A APOYAR A LA
LEY A 9370. CUATRO A UNA PARTE
FUIMOS AFECTADO DE DE LOS
DESPIDIO. EL NUEVO DUENO DE
TWITTER. EL MAS ESTE GUSTARIA
QUÊ LOS APOYAN PORQUE MUCHOS
JANITOR TRABAJAMOS Y MUCHAS
COMPANIAS AHORA SE ESTAN
METIENDO A TRABAJAR Y QUÊ LO
ESTAN QUITANDO PUESTO Y NO
ESTAMOS VIENDO BELORADO Y
ESPERAMOS EN TODOS USTEDES QUÊ
LOS PUEDEN APOYAR. SO HIS NAME
IS MARTIN. HE'S ONE OF THE. I'M
SORRY. THANK YOU. HIS NAME IS
MARTIN. HE'S ONE OF THE MEMBERS
THAT USED TO WORK AT TWITTER,
NOW KNOWN AS X, HE SAYS THAT HE
LOST HIS JOB AND HE FEELS LIKE
JANITORS ARE NOT BEING TREATED.
FAIRLY. THEY NEED MORE
REPRESENTATION. THEY'LL LIKE FOR
YOU GUYS TO PLEASE CONSIDER THIS
BILL THAT'S GOING TO HELP HIM.
AND ALL OF THE 5000 MEMBERS THAT
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED, HE HE HAS
BEEN THROUGH A LOT EVER SINCE
THAT LOSS, OF WHEN HE LOST HIS
JOB OVER AT TWITTER. SO HE'D
LIKE FOR YOU GUYS TO CONSIDER
PASSING THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, THOSE IN SUPPORT OF,
SOME ROUHANI'S BILL, PLEASE COME
TO THE MICROPHONE. SHANE GUZMAN,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB 2374,
PLEASE APPROACH. NAME
AFFILIATION. POSITION. MY NAME
IS ALICIA RUIZ. YENDO A LA LEY A
B 2370 CUATRO. THANK YOU. I
ROMNEY CARNEY WITH SEIU LOCAL 87
AND I'M IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR MEMBERS
ELMER LOZADA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT SB 2374. IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY. GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MARIELLA. MY UNION
REPRESENTATIVE FROM SEIU LOCAL
87, AND I SUPPORT AB 2374. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS
IN SUPPORT, SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING, LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 2374, PLEASE COME TO THE
EITHER TABLE OR THE MICROPHONE.
OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON. ASHLEY
HOFFMAN, BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. I JUST REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR. THEY'VE HAD A
LOT OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS
BILL WITH US AND AMENDMENTS JUST
REALLY ONE STICKING POINT ABOUT
THE BILL REQUIRING THE AWARDING
AUTHORITY TO NOTIFY THE UNION
ABOUT A CHANGE IN CONTRACT, AND
THEY COULD BE SUED IN COURT IF
THEY FAIL TO DO SO. AND FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE, THAT OBLIGATION
SHOULD FALL ON THE CONTRACTOR,
WHICH IS THE ONE THAT IS
BARGAINING WITH THAT UNION. SO
WE ARE CONTINUING TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS TO SEE IF THERE'S
A WAY THAT WE CAN GET AT THE
PROBLEM OF THAT, YOU KNOW, IF
THE SPONSORS ARE SEEING, WHILE
ADDRESSING OUR CONCERNS. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS OTHERS WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 2374. JAMIE
HOFF WITH THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANKS.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
STEPHANIE STRADA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION AND THE BUILDING
OWNERS AND MANAGERS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA, IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANKS. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE, LET'S
NOW BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SEEING NO QUESTIONS. IS THERE A
MOTION? SENATOR, SENATOR ASHBY
MOVES THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S. THANK YOU. AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE OPPOSITION. REALLY JUST ONE
SMALL ISSUE REMAINING THAT WE'RE
CONTINUING TO TALK TO THEM ABOUT
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. MADAM SECRETARY, IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR ASHBY.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER 43, AB
2374. THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG
UMBERG. AYE. WILK NØ. WILK. NO.
ALLEN ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
CABALLERO TUDDRUSSEL. RUSSELL.
AYE. LAIRD ELLO. ELLO. NO. ROTH
STERNE. WAHAB 3 TO 2. 3 TO 2.
WE'LL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL.
ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU. NEXT ITEM
44 AB 2741 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HANEY. GO AHEAD. FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS TODAY AND
I APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
FEEDBACK ON THE BILL. THIS BILL
IS IN RESPONSE TO THE INCREASE
OF RENTAL CAR THEFTS OCCURRING
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW. RENTAL
CARS ARE BEING STOLEN AT AN
ALARMING RATES, WITH RENTAL CAR
COMPANIES REPORTING THAT THEY
HAVE HAD A 266% INCREASE IN
VEHICLE THEFTS OVER THE PAST
THREE YEARS. UNFORTUNATELY,
RENTAL CAR COMPANIES DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO INTERVENE IN A
TIMELY FASHION. UNDER CURRENT
LAW, WHEN A CAR IS MISSING OR
STOLEN, TRACKING SYSTEMS CANNOT
BE LEGALLY ACTIVATED UNTIL THE
CAR HAS BEEN MISSING FOR 72
HOURS PAST ITS RETURN TIME. THIS
MEANS THAT THERE ARE THREE WHOLE
DAYS WHERE THE LOCATION OF THE
VEHICLE IS UNKNOWN, AND BY THE
TIME TRACKING SYSTEMS ARE
ACTIVATED, THE VEHICLES ARE
OFTEN RECOVERED SEVERELY DAMAGED
OR WITH STOLEN GOODS. MAIL AND
PACKAGES INSIDE. SOME COMPANIES
ARE REPORTING THAT BY THE TIME
THEY CAN LOCATE THE VEHICLE, IT
SHOWS THAT THEIR LAST KNOWN
LOCATION IS OUTSIDE OF THE
UNITED STATES. THIS IS A SIMPLE
COMMON SENSE SOLUTION. INCREASE
TO THE TO RESPOND TO INCREASING
RATES OF RENTAL CAR THEFT.
ALLOWING RENTAL CAR COMPANIES TO
INITIATE VEHICLE RECOVERY 24
HOURS AFTER FAILURE TO RETURN,
RATHER THAN 72 HOURS. THIS WOULD
MEAN INTERVENTION BEFORE A CAR
HAS BEEN USED IN A CRIME BROKEN
DOWN IN A REMOTE LOCATION, OR
EVEN LEFT THE COUNTRY AND HELP
THEM RECOVER VALUABLE ASSETS AND
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY. I'M HERE
TO TESTIFY WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS SHARKY
LAGUANA FROM THE AMERICAN CAR
RENTAL ASSOCIATION, AND JOHN
MOFFITT, ON BEHALF OF ENTERPRISE
. WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST?
I'LL GO FIRST. THANK YOU, CHAIR,
AND THANK YOU, COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I'M SHARKY LAGUANA. I
AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
CAR RENTAL ASSOCIATION. I'M NOT
A PAID LOBBYIST. IT'S A
VOLUNTEER ROLE. I RUN A SMALL,
VAN RENTAL BUSINESS. I HELP
BANDS GO ON TOUR. THAT'S WHAT I
DO. I HELP TOURING MUSICIANS
TOUR. TOUR THE US. WHAT? I USED
TO BE, WHEN I STARTED THIS
BUSINESS IN 2003, FOR THE FIRST
20 YEARS, I THINK I HAD TWO
STOLEN VANS. BOTH OF THEM, BOTH
OF WHICH WERE RETURNED IN THE
PAST YEAR. I'VE HAD 12 IN THE
PAST THREE WEEKS. I'VE HAD FOUR.
THERE'S BEEN AN EXPLOSION IN
CRIME, THEFT, RINGS THAT HAVE
IDENTIFIED A PATH THAT IS VERY
HARD FOR THE CAR RENTAL INDUSTRY
TO ADDRESS. THEY ARE ASKING
PEOPLE TO RENT A CAR ON THEIR
BEHALF. THE FOLKS SHOWING UP TO
RENT THE VEHICLE HAVE A VALID
LIVE DRIVER'S LICENSE. THEY HAVE
A CLEAN CREDIT RECORD. THEY HAVE
NO CRIMINAL HISTORY. AND THEN
THESE PEOPLE PICK UP THE CAR AND
THEN THEY HAND IT TO WHO? THE
THEFT RING THAT'S BEHIND THIS.
AND THEN THE VEHICLE DISAPPEARS
AND WE ARE OUR INDUSTRY. I'VE
NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
AND THE MANY YEARS THAT I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED WITH THIS INDUSTRY
AND MY NINE YEARS ON THE BOARD
AND MY PAST FOUR YEARS AS
SERVING AS PRESIDENT OF THE
ASSOCIATION, THE GPS, THE WHOLE
POINT OF, OF THE GPS HERE IS
WE'RE MOVING IT FROM 72 HOURS TO
24 HOURS WHEN WE CAN ACTIVATE IT
, I'LL REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT
UBER AND LYFT KNOW WHERE YOU ARE
EVERY SECOND THAT YOU'RE IN
THEIR VEHICLE, EVEN THOUGH THEY
DON'T OWN THE VEHICLE AT ALL,
I'LL ALSO MAKE THE POINT THAT
NONE OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
INTEREST IN ARRESTING ANYBODY.
ALL WE WANT IS TO RECOVER OUR
ASSET. AND IN FACT, BY
TRIGGERING THE GPS, BECAUSE THE
PRESUMPTION OF EMBEZZLEMENT
DOESN'T HAPPEN UNTIL FIVE DAYS.
IF WE CAN TRIGGER THE GPS AND
RECOVER OUR VEHICLE USING JUST A
TOW COMPANY OR WHAT HAVE YOU, WE
CAN ACTUALLY STOP AND ARREST. WE
CAN STOP. AND THE LAST POINT
THAT I'LL MAKE IS THAT, STOLEN
VEHICLES ARE OFTEN USED TO
COMMIT MORE CRIMES IN MY CASE,
THANK YOU. SIR. YOU'RE GOING TO
URGE AN AYE VOTE. I BET, ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. JOHN MOFFATT, ON BEHALF
OF ENTERPRISE MOBILITY, WE
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND THE
ONGOING CONVERSATION ABOUT ONE
OF THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
DEALING WITH KEYS. THERE'S AN
EXISTING PROVISION IN LAW THAT
EVEN IF THE RENTER DOES NOT
RETURN THE KEYS AFTER THE
VEHICLE IS STOLEN, THERE IS A
PRESUMPTION THAT THEY ARE NOT
LIABLE, WE BELIEVE THAT THAT
THAT PRESUMPTION, SHOULD BE
REMOVED FROM THE LAW. IF THE
RENTER CAN RETURN THE KEY, THEY
RETAIN THAT PRESUMPTION FOR NOT
FOR HAVING NO LIABILITY FOR THAT
STOLEN VEHICLE. KEEPING IN MIND,
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT CRIMES.
WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT
LIABILITY FOR THE STOLEN VEHICLE
, FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE, WE LOOK
AT IT AND WE ARE KEEPING IN THE
LAW THE CLEAR AND CONVINCING
STANDARD THAT WE MUST PROVE
BEFORE A RENTER COULD BE LIABLE
FOR A STOLEN VEHICLE. WE THINK
IT'S REASONABLE, ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THE CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH, WITH STOLEN
VEHICLES TODAY AND THE FACT THAT
THESE STOLEN VEHICLES ARE USED
IN OTHER CRIMES THAT HOPEFULLY
IF, IF A, IF A WAYWARD RENTER
KNOWS THAT THERE COULD BE SOME
LIABILITY FOR THE STOLEN
VEHICLE, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THAT WILL DISSUADE THEM FROM
ANSWERING A FACEBOOK AD OR WHAT
HAVE YOU TO GO AND BE A PART OF
THAT ACTIVITY. AND SO AGAIN, WE
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS AND
APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
CONVERSATION OVER THE SUMMER
RECESS ON THAT ISSUE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, MR. MOFFAT. ALL
RIGHT. OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF, AB
2741, PLEASE APPROACH. GOOD
AFTERNOON, JOHN ROSS, FOR THE
HERTZ CORPORATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CAITLIN JOHNSON WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF AVIS AND
CAL TRAVEL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE. LET'S
NOW TURN TO OPPOSITION. I SEE
OPPOSITION COMING FORWARD. ALL
RIGHT, MR. AL, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS, MR. CHAIRMAN. TODAY
WALKING BRISKLY INTO THE ROOM,
NOT RUNNING INTO THE ROOM,
ROBERT HERRERA WITH THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA. IN
OPPOSITION. FIRST OF ALL, I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU. YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF, ALSO THE AUTHOR
AND I THOUGHT IT WAS LAGUNA. SO
I THOUGHT YOUR NAME WAS MORE
NAUTICAL THAN IT EVEN IS, WE HAD
A GOOD CONVERSATION ABOUT ABOUT
THE BILL, AND WE'VE AGREED TO
CONTINUE TO TALK REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH. I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THE HISTORY
ON THIS, AND THE ANALYSIS DOES A
PRETTY GOOD JOB TOWARDS THE END
OF IT, OF BRINGING THIS OUT IS A
IS A LITTLE MORE MURKY THAN I
THINK THE RENTAL CAR INDUSTRY
WOULD LIKE YOU TO THINK, TO WIT,
HERTZ REPORTED CARS, AND THIS
ONLY CAME OUT THROUGH THEIR
BANKRUPTCY, BY THE WAY.
OTHERWISE WE WOULD NOT KNOW
THIS. HERTZ REPORTED CARS AS
STOLEN, WHEN IN FACT THE
CONSUMER HAD EITHER EXTENDED THE
STAY AND THEY HAD TEXT RECEIPTS
OR OTHER WAYS TO PROVE THAT THEY
HAD EXTENDED THE STAY, OR THEY
JUST MESSED UP AND LOST TRACK OF
IT. AND LITERALLY PEOPLE WERE IN
JAIL FOR AS LONG AS SIX MONTHS
WHEN THE CAR WAS NEVER STOLEN.
THESE WERE CONSUMERS WHO ALL
THEY DID WAS SAY, I NEED MORE
TIME, OR THEY BROUGHT IT BACK
AND IT GOT SCREWED UP IN THE
SYSTEM. SO THE HISTORY OF THE
INDUSTRY DOES NOT EXACTLY
ENGENDER A VERY, VERY HIGH LEVEL
OF TRUST. AND SO IN LOOKING AT
THIS BILL, AND WE APPRECIATE THE
OTHER PROVISIONS THAT HAVE COME
OUT, MR. CHAIRMAN, AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING SOME
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE INDUSTRY,
BUT I THINK THAT THAT THERE'S A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN A COMPANY
THAT HELPS BANDS GO ON TOUR AND
HERTZ AND AVIS, AND WE'RE REALLY
ONLY DOWN TO THE BIG THREE. I
MEAN, THERE'S LOTS OF BRAND
NAMES OUT THERE, BUT THERE'S
ONLY THREE BIG OWNERS LEFT. SO
YOU'VE HAD YOU ESSENTIALLY HAVE
AN OLIGOPOLY LEFT IN THIS
INDUSTRY, AND A HANDFUL OF
INDEPENDENTS. SO I THINK THAT
DISTINCTION IS AN IMPORTANT ONE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE OUGHT TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT. WHEN WE LOOK
AT THIS TRACKING TECHNOLOGY AND
WE LOOK AT CONSUMER PROTECTION.
SO WITH THAT, WE APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WILL BE
ONGOING. AS FOR A NO VOTE TODAY,
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE SEEING
NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES, SENATOR
WILK. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. BUT
IF YOU WANT TO BUILD TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS, YOU SHOULD DO THIS
NEXT SESSION. REQUIRE THAT THESE
COMPANIES GIVE YOU A FULL TANK
OF GAS WHEN YOU RENT IT. I THINK
IT'S A BUSINESS MODEL THAT YOU
YOU GET. IT'S LIKE, YOU KNOW,
TWO THIRDS AND THEN YOU'RE AT
THE PUMP AND YOU GO, WHAT? AND I
ALWAYS GIVE THEM MORE BECAUSE
I'M STUPID. I ALWAYS GIVE THEM
MORE THAN THEY DESERVE. SO THAT
WOULD BE A GREAT BILL. AND I'D
EVEN, AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN, COME
UP AND TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF YOUR
ORGANIZATION. SO THINK ABOUT WE
CAN'T AUTHOR IT NEXT YEAR. MR.
NÓ, I SAID, I COME AS A PRIVATE
CITIZEN. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. I'M
GOING TO FLY IN FROM AMERICA.
THANK YOU. SENATOR WILK. SENATOR
WILK IS A FREQUENT RENTER OF
VEHICLES. I WOULD WELCOME YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN OMNIBUS RENTAL
CAR BILL NEXT YEAR. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR RUSSO HAS MOVED THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, MADAM
SECRETARY. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR RUSSO. THIS IS FILE ITEM
44, AB 2741. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED, BURKE, I BURKE
I WILK I WILK. AYE. ALLEN ASHBY.
CABALLERO DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE.
LAIRD NHIÀU I ELI. ROTH. STERN I
STERN. AYE. WAHAB 5 TO 0 FIVE
ZERO. WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
THANK YOU. AND I HAVE A
JONES-SAWYER BILL YOU'RE GOING
TO DO ASSEMBLY MEMBER. JONES.
SAWYER. BILL CONGRATULATIONS. GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER, I'M
PRESENTING 2136 AND HE IS
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. THIS WILL CLARIFY
THE LEGALITY OF ACCESSING AND
PROVIDING DRUG CHECKING SERVICES
IN CALIFORNIA, ALTHOUGH DRUG
CHECKING EQUIPMENT AND TESTING
ARE PERMITTED IN CALIFORNIA, THE
DRUGS PARAPHERNALIA AND
POSSESSION LAWS PROHIBIT DRUG
TESTING AND ANALYZING FOR
SUBSTANCE USERS. SO THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE HELPING PEOPLE TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH ARE CURRENTLY OPERATING
IN A LEGAL GRAY AREA. THIS WILL
ADDRESS THE GAP IN STATE LAW TO
ENCOURAGE MORE CITIES TO OFFER
DRUG CHECKING SERVICES AND
PARTNERSHIP WITH CBOS RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS, AND STATE AND
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
AND PROVIDE LEGAL, CRIMINAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE PROTECTIONS FOR
DRUG CHECKING SERVICES, WHICH
CAN SAVE LIVES, AND WE SHOULD
NOT MAKE IT ILLEGAL FOR PEOPLE
TO MAKE SURE THEY KNOW WHAT'S IN
A DRUG SO THAT THEY CAN PROTECT
THEMSELVES. AND OTHERS WITH ME
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL ARE IS
DOCTOR CHELSEA SCHOBER WITH DRUG
CHECKING LOS ANGELES AND GRAY
GARDNER GRODNER, ACTING STATE
DIRECTOR FOR DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. ALL RIGHT.
WONDERFUL. THANK YOU. GREAT.
THANK YOU. SO THANK YOU, CHAIR
UMBERG. AND VICE CHAIR WILK FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY. I AM AN
EPIDEMIOLOGIST AND FACULTY
MEMBER AT THE UCLA DAVID GEFFEN
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE. BUT TODAY, I
SPEAK ONLY ON BEHALF OF MYSELF
AS AN INDIVIDUAL. I'M ALSO THE
PRINCIPAL INVESTIGATOR OF DRUG
CHECKING LOS ANGELES, WHICH WE
STARTED AS A RESEARCH STUDY, AND
IT'S NOW A CDC FUNDED PUBLIC
HEALTH PROGRAM. IN MY
PROFESSIONAL OPINION, I VIEW
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES TESTING OR
COLLOQUIALLY, DRUG CHECKING AS A
KEY STRATEGY TO PREVENT
OVERDOSE. THERE ARE THREE MAIN
BENEFITS TO DRUG CHECKING.
FIRST, THERE'S THE DIRECT
BENEFIT TO THE TO THE PERSON
HAVING THEIR SUBSTANCES TESTED.
WITH THAT INFORMATION, WE RUN A
SAMPLE. IT ONLY TAKES ABOUT TEN
MINUTES IN THE FIELD. WE'RE ABLE
TO GIVE PEOPLE SOME ANSWERS
RIGHT AWAY WITH THAT
INFORMATION, PEOPLE CAN MAKE
HEALTHIER AND SAFER CHOICES.
SECONDLY, DRUG CHECKING,
PROVIDING IT IN A LOW BARRIER
AND NON-JUDGMENTAL WAY IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE PEOPLE IN
OTHER SERVICES. THROUGH OUR
PROGRAM, WE HAVE ENGAGED PEOPLE
WHO CAME IN FOR DRUG CHECKING IN
, SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT, HOUSING CASE
MANAGEMENT, HIV PREVENTION AND
TREATMENT, PRIMARY CARE
SERVICES, AND MORE. AND THEN THE
THIRD BENEFIT IS THE COMMUNITY
LEVEL INFORMATION ABOUT THE
ILLICIT DRUG SUPPLY. IT'S THE
DRUG SUPPLY CHANGES VERY
QUICKLY. AND IT'S VERY
CHALLENGING TO RECOGNIZE THOSE
CHANGES THROUGH TRADITIONAL DATA
SOURCES. WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
RESPOND TO THE THREAT OF
XYLAZINE FASTER IN LOS ANGELES
BECAUSE DRUG CHECKING LÀ
IDENTIFIED THIS VETERINARY
TRANQUILIZER IN SAMPLES. BEFORE
WE WOULD HAVE KNOWN FROM OTHER
SOURCES LIKE POSTMORTEM
TOXICOLOGY OR LAW ENFORCEMENT
SEIZURES, AND WE USE THAT
INFORMATION TO PARTNER WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
GET PREVENTION RESOURCES TO
PEOPLE WHO NEED THEM. SINCE WE
STARTED THE PROGRAM ABOUT 18
MONTHS AGO, WE'VE TESTED OVER
700 DRUG PRODUCT SAMPLES ALL
PROVIDED VOLUNTARILY AND
ANONYMOUSLY. THE WORK WE'RE
DOING IS CURRENTLY LEGAL BECAUSE
WE DO IT IN THE CONTEXT OF
SYRINGE SERVICE PROGRAMS. AB
2136 WOULD ALLOW US WOULD ALLOW
PROGRAMS TO EXPAND TO OTHER
SETTINGS SUCH AS CLINICS,
FESTIVALS, UNIVERSITY. I ASSUME
YOU'RE GOING TO ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE? I AM, YES, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY. NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I'M GREG COULDN'T BE
HERE TODAY, BUT I'M HERE IN HIS
PLACE. MY NAME IS NORMA
PALACIOS. POLICY COORDINATOR
WITH THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO THE CHAIR FOR
MEETING WITH US TO DISCUSS THE
INTENT OF THE BILL. YOUR INSIGHT
AND CONTRIBUTIONS WILL
STRENGTHEN OUR EFFORTS TO
ACCOMPLISH OUR SHARED OBJECTIVE
OF ADDRESSING THE UNPRECEDENTED
OVERDOSE CRISIS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE COLLABORATION ON
THIS BILL IS A TESTAMENT TO THE
MEANINGFUL DISCUSSION AND
COLLECTIVE ACTION THAT CAN TAKE
PLACE TO OFFER CALIFORNIANS WITH
EVIDENCE BASED POLICY SOLUTIONS
THAT COULD IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES FOR THOSE STRUGGLING
WITH SUBSTANCE USE THAT IS FREE
FROM STIGMA AND CRIMINALIZATION
AND MEET THEIR NEEDS. AB 136 IS
A CRITICAL TOOL IN OUR EFFORTS
TO IMPROVE OUR RESPONSE TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS, AND I
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE
OPPOSITION WAS WAS REMOVED AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER AB 2136. THE
SALAS POLICY INSTITUTE, AND ALSO
PROVIDING ME TOOS ON BEHALF OF
DELIVERING INNOVATION AND
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. SAN
FRANCISCO TREATMENT ON DEMAND
COALITION. ANY POSITIVE CHANGE,
INC, NATIONAL HARM REDUCTION
COALITION, THE GUBBIO PROJECT,
HEALTHRIGHT 360 CALIFORNIANS
UNITED FOR A RESPONSIBLE BUDGET,
CURB GLIDE, LARKIN STREET YOUTH
SERVICES, SAN LUIS OBISPO
SYRINGE EXCHANGE AND OVERDOSE
PREVENTION. LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN BEING
ESTARÁ. HUMAN SERVICES, THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE, TENDERLOIN NEIGHBORHOOD
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION,
COMMUNITY HEALTH PROJECT, LA
BALANCED AND PERFECTION, DRUG
USER HEALTH ADVISORY COMMITTEE
OF SOUTHERN ALAMEDA COUNTY, THE
SIDEWALK PROJECT, FACE TO FACE
AND SONOMA COUNTY AIDS NETWORK.
THANK YOU. BECCA KRAMER MATTER
ON BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN SUPPORT, STEPHANIE
ESTRADA ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
LATINAS FOR REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS, CARLOS GUTIERREZ
HERE ON BEHALF OF CAP IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE
ELSE APPROACHING, LET'S NOW TURN
TO THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYERS AB 2136, PLEASE
APPROACH SEEING NO ONE ELSE, I,
I THINK THAT'S YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT IS. THAT'S ANOTHER MEMBER
OF THE ASSEMBLY BEING ASKED TO
TAKE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IS
WHAT THAT IS. SO RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT. SO IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION, IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO, AB 2136, PLEASE
APPROACH SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING. ALL RIGHT.
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE. IS THERE A MOTION
THE SENATE WILL MOVE THE BILL?
SENATOR RUSSELL MOVES THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES? SAWYER,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. OKAY MADAM
SECRETARY, IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR RUSSO. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS PHIL, ITEM 39 AB
2136. THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG UMBERG.
AYE. WILK. NÓ. WILK. NO. ALLEN
ASHBY. CABALLERO DURAZO.
RUSSELL. AYE. LAIRD MELLO.
YELLO. NO ROTH. STERN WAHAB. 2
TO 2. 2 TO 2. WE'RE GOING TO PUT
THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT, I SEE IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE HERE. HE IS
NOT ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARON. OH.
I'M SORRY. OH, JUST IF ANYONE'S
HERE ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE'S
BILL, YOU NEED NOT STAY ANY
LONGER BECAUSE IT'S BEEN PULLED.
ALL RIGHT? SO REMEMBER, CALL
ROLL. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, I'LL
GO AND FILE AN ORDER AND BEGIN
WITH AB 459. I'D LIKE TO START
BY THANKING THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE WORK ON
THE BILL. AND I'LL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. AB
459 WOULD MAKE IMPLEMENTATION
FIXES TO THE RACIAL AND IDENTITY
PROFILING ACT. RIPA THAT WOULD
IMPROVE THE FINAL DATA, SETS
OVERALL QUALITY AND FACILITATE
BETTER PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION. IN 2015, THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB 953, WHICH
ESTABLISHED RIPA TO ELIMINATE
RACIAL AND IDENTITY PROFILING BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT. UNDER EXISTING
LAW REPORTING AGENCIES SUCH AS
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
CHP ARE REQUIRED TO REPORT DATA
ON POLICE STOPS TO THE DOJ
ANNUALLY. HOWEVER, FOLLOWING THE
COMPLETION OF THE 2023 RIPA DATA
REPORTING PERIOD, 14% OF
REPORTING AGENCIES SUBMITTED
INCOMPLETE SUBMISSIONS OR DATA
WITH ERRORS THAT COULD NOT BE
REMEDIED BEFORE TRANSMITTAL. THE
RIPA BOARD FOR THEIR ANALYSIS
AND ANNUAL REPORT. ADDITIONALLY,
WHILE THE STATUTE REQUIRES ALL
RIPA DATA TO BE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE AND SPECIFIES THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION OF THE INDIVIDUAL
STOPPED OR THE OFFICERS INVOLVED
ARE NOT REPORTED. PII IS STILL
BEING INCLUDED IN THE OPEN TEXT
DATA FIELDS. THIS IS DESPITE
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM THE DOJ, AND HAS
LED TO MUCH OF THIS INFORMATION
BEING UNAVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
DUE TO PRIVACY CONCERNS. AB 459
ADDRESSES THESE ISSUES BY FIRST
UPDATING THE ANNUAL SUBMISSION
DEADLINE FROM APRIL 1ST TO MARCH
1ST, TO ALLOW THE DOJ MORE TIME
TO RESOLVE ERRORS. ADDITIONALLY,
THE BILL INCENTIVIZES REPORTING
AGENCIES TO MEET EXISTING
DEADLINES WITH MINIMAL ERRORS
OR, AT A MINIMUM, WORK WITH THE
DOJ BY INCREASING THE REPORTING
FREQUENCY TO TWICE ANNUALLY. FOR
AGENCIES THAT FAIL TO COMPLY.
LASTLY, THE BILL WOULD ADDRESS
CONCERNS RELATING TO THE
MISREPORTING OF PII IN OPEN TEXT
AND NARRATIVE FIELDS BY
ESTABLISHING A PROCESS FOR
RESEARCHERS TO APPLY FOR FULL
ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION UNDER
A CONFIDENTIALITY AGREEMENT
MODELED AFTER EXISTING
DISCLOSURE PROCESSES. FOR
INFORMATION RELATED TO FIREARMS
AND CRIMINAL HISTORY. OTHER
REQUESTS ARE SEEKING ACCESS TO
THE OPEN TEXT NARRATIVE FIELDS
MUST FILE A PRA REQUEST THROUGH
THE RESPECTIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
REPORTING AGENCY, WHICH WOULD
THEN BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
REDACTING ANY PII, INCLUDING
THOSE FIELDS. WITH ME TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS JUSTIN ROSA, A
DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR WITH
THE OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, AND DAMON BROWN,
SPECIAL ASSISTANT ATTORNEY
GENERAL, WHO IS AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR, AND HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS AB 459
WITH YOU TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSOR, ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB
BONTA, WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
STRENGTHENING PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS IN THE BILL AND
APPLAUD ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALL FOR
HIS AUTHORSHIP TO ADD TO THE
AUTHOR'S PRESENTATION. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
REALIZED THE NEED FOR AB 459
DURING OUR IMPLEMENTATION OF
RIPA. UNDER THE CURRENT LAW, DOJ
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR COLLECTING
THE DATA, WORKING ACCORDINGLY TO
REMEDY ERRORS THAT ARE SUBMITTED
TO DOJ, AND ALSO RESPONSE TO
RESPECTIVE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUESTS. WHILE WE WOULD HAVE
LIKED TO INTRODUCE THIS BILL
EARLIER, WE HAD TO WAIT UNTIL
THE 2023 DATA TO ENSURE THAT ANY
PROPOSED CHANGES TO THE RIPA
STATUTE WERE EVIDENCE BASED AND
TAILORED TO OUR FINDINGS. THE
BILL BEFORE YOU, THEREFORE,
BENEFITS FROM THAT PASSAGE OF
TIME, AS IT IS INFORMED BY TWO
YEARS OF FULL STATEWIDE
REPORTING, WITH THE LAST
REPORTING PERIOD ENDING RECENTLY
ON APRIL FIRST, TO ESTABLISH A
SENSE OF SCALE AND EMPHASIZE THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS, OVER 500
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SUBMIT
RIPA DATA TO DOJ. 4.5 MILLION
STOPS WERE SUBMITTED IN 2022.
4.7 MILLION STOPS WERE SUBMITTED
IN 2023. HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTES THAT THE LETTER
INTENT OF RIPA DATA COLLECTION
IS FULLY REALIZED ALREADY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT SEEING NO ONE ELSE.
OH, HERE WE GO. OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT, TRACY ROSENBERG, ON
BEHALF OF OAKLAND. PRIVACY IN
SUPPORT, AS AMENDED. THANK YOU.
IN SUPPORT, IGNACIO HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
POLICING EQUITY. WE DO NOT HAVE
AN OFFICIAL POSITION, BUT IN
COMMUNICATION WITH THE SPONSORS
AND TRYING TO CLARIFY SOME OF
THE LANGUAGE, LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM ALREADY. THANK
YOU. BENJAMIN COHEN OF MOUNTAIN
VIEW IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. OTHER SUPPORT, SEEING NO
ONE ELSE APPROACHED THE
MICROPHONE, LET'S NOW TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 459, PLEASE
APPROACH. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS. CORY SALZILLO, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION,
RESPECTFULLY, IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL, THE TWO CONCERNS WE
HAVE. FIRST, THE PROVISION THAT
SAYS IF THERE ARE UNRESOLVED
ISSUES OR LINGERING ERRORS OR
WHATEVER THE TERMS ARE, WHICH
ARE, BY THE WAY, NOT DEFINED IN
THE BILL, IF YOU HAVE THOSE
THINGS, THEN THE, THE SORT OF
REMEDY OR THE RESPONSE IS THAT
IN THE SUBSEQUENT CALENDAR YEAR
OR REPORTING YEAR, YOU HAVE TO
REPORT TWICE, IT'S NOT CLEAR TO
ME OR TO MY CLIENT THAT WHEN YOU
HAVE THOSE UNRESOLVED ERRORS
WHICH COULD OR UNRESOLVED ISSUES
, THERE COULD BE ANY NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT MAKE IT DIFFICULT
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
PROCESS THE INFORMATION THAT IS
SUBMITTED PURSUANT TO RIPA AND
THE SORT OF BLUNT RESPONSE OF,
WELL, YOU JUST HAVE TO REPORT
TWO TIMES NEXT YEAR. IT'S NOT
ALWAYS GOING TO REMEDY WHATEVER
THE ISSUE IS. IF IT'S NOT A YEAR
OVER YEAR LINGERING ISSUE,
THAT'S ISSUE NUMBER ONE. ISSUE
NUMBER TWO IS, THE PROVISION
HAVING TO DO WITH THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT, THE NARRATIVE TEXT
FIELD OR THE OPEN FIELD AS IT'S
REFERRED TO, WHAT THE BILL DOES,
AS I'M SURE WAS EXPLAINED, WAS
IT IT RELIEVES THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FROM THE BURDEN OF
RESPONDING TO THOSE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT REQUESTS. AND
ENFORCES THAT SOLELY WHICH IT
CURRENTLY EXISTS TODAY. BUT IT
NOW SAYS WE ARE NO LONGER IN
THAT BUSINESS. WE DOJ IS NO
LONGER IN THAT BUSINESS. LOCALS,
YOU HANDLE IT BECAUSE YOU ARE
THE ONES WHO ARE SCREWING IT UP.
IN SO MANY WORDS. MY WORDS
RESPECTFULLY, SO BOTH OF THOSE
PROVISIONS, WE FEEL, PUTS PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT BURDENS ON THE LOCAL
AGENCIES, AND, YOU KNOW, FROM
SHERIFF'S PERSPECTIVE, WE DID
NOT SUPPORT THE CREATION OF RIPA
IN THE FIRST PLACE. THIS SEEMS
PUNITIVE AND WILL RESULT IN
COSTS AND RESOURCE DEPLETION FOR
THOSE REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION MEMBERS JONATHAN
FELDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION, ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUE ERNIE. THANK
YOU, THE COMMENT WITH RESPECT TO
UNDEFINED TERMS, WE DON'T LIKE
UNDEFINED TERMS. LEAVING HAVE
YOU HAVE YOU MR. HAVE YOU
PROVIDED ANY DEFINITION TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA TO HELP
DEFINE THE TERMS THAT YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT BEING VAGUE? I
HAVE NOT, AND I WOULD SAY THAT
THERE'S TWO REASONS FOR THAT.
ONE, THEY JUST CAME UP WITH THIS
AMEND, YOU KNOW, I UNDERSTAND
THEY WANTED TO WAIT UNTIL THEY
HAD TWO FULL YEARS OF REPORTING
DATA TO BRING THE BILL. I'M NOT
SURE WHY THEY NEEDED TO DO IT.
IN JULY OF THE SECOND YEAR OF A
TWO YEAR SESSION. BUT THAT'S
NEITHER HERE NOR THERE. THE
OTHER ISSUE, THE ONLY THING I'VE
HAD DESCRIBED TO ME IS, PERHAPS
IF SOMEBODY IF AN AGENCY WAITS
UNTIL SORT OF THE, YOU KNOW, IF
MARCH 31ST IS THE LAST DAY OR
MARCH 30TH, THEN THEY WAIT AND
THEN EVEN IF IT'S A MINOR, YOU
KNOW, SORT OF DATA
CLASSIFICATION OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, THEY JUST RUN OUT OF TIME.
AND WE SUGGESTED, I THINK
RESPECTFULLY, THAT IF THE ISSUE
IS THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS MORE
TIME TO LOOK AT THE DATA AND
PROCESS IT AND WHATEVER THE
ISSUE IS THAT THEY BUILD IN MORE
TIME BETWEEN THEN AND WHEN THOSE
DATA HAVE TO BE GIVEN TO THE
RIPA BOARD FOR THE COMPLETION OF
THEIR REPORT, NOT TO MOVE BACK
THE TIMING. AND AGAIN, I, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THOSE REALLY
THOSE UNRESOLVED ISSUES ARE.
WE'VE HAD TWO CONVERSATIONS. AND
SOME CLARITY WOULD BE HELPFUL IN
THAT REGARD. OKAY. I'M JUST
REFERRING TO THE UNDEFINED TERMS
THAT YOU HAD MENTIONED EARLIER,
AND I WOULD ASK THE, THE AUTHOR,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S KALRA, JUST,
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE THINGS WE
LIKE TO DO IS DEFINE TERMS AS
THE BILLS LEAVE THE COMMITTEE.
SO JUST ASK YOU, AS THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD IS TO DEFINE THOSE
TERMS. OKAY. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. OTHER OTHER QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE. IS THERE
A MOTION. YES, SIR. SENATOR WILK
HAS A COMMENT OR QUESTION. I
DON'T REALLY KNOW. I'M PROBABLY
GOING TO LAY OFF THIS BILL
TODAY, BUT I JUST WANT TO SHARE
AN EXPERIENCE OF MINE. AND IT'S
BEEN LIKE TWO YEARS RUNNING AND
IT'S STILL UNRESOLVED. SO I HAVE
A CONSTITUENT IN THE ANTELOPE
VALLEY, FORMER, CORRECTIONS
OFFICER, SMALL BUSINESS OWNER,
BLACK GENTLEMAN, IN FACT, A
LEADER IN THAT COMMUNITY WHO'S
BEEN A CRITIC OF LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT, AND RIGHTLY SO.
THEY'RE UNDER FEDERAL OVERSIGHT
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN ABUSES ALL
OF A SUDDEN. DO YOU DO DOJ COMES
UP IN FRONT OF HIS KIDS AND
EVERYTHING, TAKES HIS CUT, CUFFS
THEM, TAKES HIS GUNS, LEAVES. WE
STILL DON'T KNOW WHY THAT EVER
HAPPENED, MY GUT TELLS ME
THERE'S BEEN SOME ABUSE. WHETHER
IT WAS THE LOCALS ASKING DOJ TO
DO IT OR. BUT, LIKE, THERE'S NO.
AND I'VE, I'VE SUPPORTED MONEY
GOING FOR THESE PROGRAMS, BUT WE
STILL DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER. IT'S
BEEN OVER TWO YEARS AND YOU
KNOW, DOJ STILL HAS HIS GUN
SOMEWHERE ARRESTED AND, DETAINED
IN FRONT OF HIS SMALL CHILDREN.
AND IT'S JUST, I JUST I GET
CONCERNED ABOUT ABUSES OF THE
GOVERNMENT. AND THAT'S CERTAINLY
IN MY OPINION, WITHOUT ANY OTHER
INFORMATION. I BELIEVE THAT WAS
AN ABUSE. SO I'M JUST GOING TO
LAY OFF BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW.
AND HOPEFULLY I GET BETTER
EDUCATED BEFORE IT GETS TO THE
FLOOR. ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, SEEING
NONE. IS THERE A MOTION? I'M
LOOKING AT YOU, SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR STERN HAS MOVED THE
BILL, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, AND WE'LL TAKE YOUR
THOUGHTS UNDER CONSIDERATION,
MR. CHAIR. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FOR ITEM 33 AB 459. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG I
UMBERG I WILK NOT VOTING. ALLEN
ASHBY. CABALLERO DURAZO DURAZO I
LAIRD. LAIRD I NILO. NO MILO.
NO. ROTH STERN. STERN I WAHAB. 4
TO 1. 4 TO 1. PARTY BILLS ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
YOU'VE GOT SOME OTHER STUFF. SO
NEXT BILL FOR THE BAR BILL ONLY
AB 2347, PLEASE. ALL RIGHT, AB
2347. THANK YOU. I WILL START BY
SAYING I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. AND WITH
THOSE CHANGES, AB 2347 WILL MAKE
JUST TWO UPDATES TO LANDLORD
TENANT LAW. EXTEND THE TIME FOR
A TENANT TO RESPOND TO A SUMMONS
BY FIVE ADDITIONAL DAYS AND
CODIFY A TIMELINE FOR DEMURRERS
AND MOTIONS TO STRIKE HEARINGS.
EXISTING LAW STATES WHEN A
TENANT IS SERVED WITH THE
SUMMONS FOR UNLAWFUL DETAINER, A
LAWSUIT THAT IS FILED TO EVICT A
TENANT THEY HAVE ONLY FIVE DAYS
TO ANSWER. THE TENANT MAY
RECEIVE AN ADDITIONAL FIVE DAYS
TO ANSWER IF THE SUMMONS IS
SERVED BY MAIL OR SUBSTITUTED
SERVICE. THIS WINDOW IS
SIGNIFICANTLY SHORTER THAN THE
CUSTOMARY 30 DAYS FOR RESPONSE
THAT IS NORMALLY THAT NORMALLY
IS PERMITTED IN NON UNLAWFUL
DETAINER CIVIL CASES. THE DANGER
BEHIND DETERMINING SOMETHING AS
CRITICAL AS SHELTER ON SUCH A
QUICK TIMELINE IS THAT DUE
PROCESS CAN EASILY BE
COMPROMISED, ASSUMING THE TENANT
WAS PROPERLY SERVED. RESPONDING
TO AN EVICTION LAWSUIT IS NOT A
SIMPLE MATTER FOR THE LOW INCOME
TENANTS THAT MAKE UP THE VAST
MAJORITY OF EVICTION CASE
DEFENDANTS, THE DIFFICULTY IS
EXACERBATED. DECIPHERING THE
LEGAL FORMS IS COMPLEX. MAKING A
WELL-FOUNDED LEGAL ARGUMENT IS
EVEN HARDER. PRIVATE ATTORNEYS
ARE EXPENSIVE, AND LEGAL AID
SERVICES ARE IN SHORT SUPPLY.
PROCEDURALLY, TENANTS IN MOST
JURISDICTIONS TRAVEL TO THE
COURTHOUSE, WAIT IN LINE, FILL
OUT THE FORMS, MAKE COPIES, ETC.
TO DO SO. MOST TENANTS WILL HAVE
TO MISS WORK AND IF THEY HAVE
CHILDREN, ARRANGE FOR CHILD CARE
FOR ELDERLY AND DISABLED
TENANTS. THE SHORT TIME FRAME IN
WHICH TO RESPOND IS ALL THE MORE
DIFFICULT TO MEET. IF THE FIVE
DAYS RUN OUT BEFORE THE TENANT
FILES A RESPONSE, A LANDLORD CAN
GET A DEFAULT JUDGMENT AGAINST
THE TENANT, AND THEY MAY LOSE
THE CASE WITHOUT EVER GETTING
THEIR DAY IN COURT, EVEN IF THEY
ARE MERITORIOUS. BUT THEY HAVE A
MERITORIOUS DEFENSE TO THE
EVICTION. THE PURPOSE BEHIND THE
SUMMARY NATURE OF EVICTION
PROCEEDINGS IS TO ENABLE
LANDLORDS TO RECOVER POSSESSION
OF THE RENTAL PROPERTY
RELATIVELY QUICKLY, AND I WANT
TO THANK THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT ASSOCIATION FOR
WORKING WITH US TO STRIKE THE
RIGHT BALANCE AND THANK YOU TO
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL FOR THEIR
FEEDBACK AND WORKING WITH US
FURTHER ON THOSE CHANGES. WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
KAREN COLLINS, REGIONAL COUNSEL
FOR LEGAL SERVICES FOR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS KAREN
KUNTZ. I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH
LEGAL SERVICES OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THE NONPROFIT LAW
FIRM SERVES 23 MAINLY RURAL
COUNTIES COVERING MOST OF THE
STATE NORTH OF THE BAY AREA.
LAST YEAR, WE HELPED OVER 10,000
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS AND OVER
50% OF OUR CASES WERE HOUSING
CASES. IN MY ROLE AS REGIONAL
COUNSEL, I SEE A LOT OF EVICTION
CASES. I SUPPORT ATTORNEYS
PROVIDING HOUSING RELATED LEGAL
ADVICE ACROSS OUR EIGHT OFFICES.
AB 2347 MAKES SMALL BUT
PROCEDURAL CHANGES THAT BETTER
PROTECT TENANTS DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS, PREVENT UNFAIR
EVICTIONS, AND HELP CONSERVE
COURT RESOURCES BY EXTENDING THE
TIME TO RESPOND FROM FIVE DAYS
TO TEN. THE BILL GIVES TENANTS A
MORE REASONABLE TIME PERIOD TO
RESPOND TO THEIR EVICTION CASE.
ONE RESULT WILL BE THAT MORE
TENANTS ARE ABLE TO AVOID
DEFAULT JUDGMENTS IN YOLO
COUNTY, WHERE OUR OFFICE HAS A
SHRIVER GRANT WITH THE COURT,
AND WE CAN GET DATA ON DEFAULT
JUDGMENTS. AROUND 44% OF
UNLAWFUL DETAINER CASES FILED
BETWEEN 2017 AND 2019 RESULTED
IN DEFAULTS, WITH MORE TIME FOR
TENANTS TO FIND LEGAL HELP AND
RESPOND TO THE SENTENCE SUMMONS,
WE EXPECT THIS NUMBER WILL
DECREASE AND THIS WILL SAVE
ATTORNEY AND COURT RESOURCES BY
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF MOTIONS
TO SET ASIDE FILED BY TENANTS
WITH VALID REASONS FOR FAILING
TO RESPOND, AS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED, THE ANSWER FORM IS
COMPLICATED AND IT'S DIFFICULT
TO COMPLETE WITHOUT ASSISTANCE.
SO MANY TENANTS ARE NOT ABLE TO
GET HELP WITHIN THE TIME TO
RESPOND. IN OUR SACRAMENTO
OFFICE, WE CAN'T COME CLOSE TO
MEETING THE HOUSING NEEDS FOR
ALL THE LOW INCOME RESIDENTS OF
SACRAMENTO. OUR INTAKE LIST
FILLS UP EVERY DAY, AND THERE
ARE AROUND 20 TO 60 CALLS PER
DAY THAT COME IN AFTER OUR
INTAKE IS CLOSED. THIS MEANS
THAT TONS OF NOTICES AND
EVICTION CASES WE NEVER SEE. THE
ADDITIONAL TIME TO RESPOND WILL
HELP. TENANTS WILL ALLOW THEM TO
SEEK HELP EARLY, ARRANGE FOR
TRANSPORTATION, AND BE LIKELY TO
GET A TIMELY APPOINTMENT WITH
OUR ADVOCATES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BETTER, I ASSUME YOU URGE
AND I VOTE. ALL RIGHT. GREAT.
THANK YOU, OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. BRIAN AUGUSTA, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION,
PROUD SPONSOR URGENT. I VOTE ONE
ONE SECOND, IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE HALLWAY WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY, EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO ANY OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KARAS BILLS,
PLEASE COME ON INTO THE HEARING
ROOM, SO WE CAN QUEUE UP. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. NEXT. KRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SERAPHINA JOHNSON
WITH THE HOUSING NOW CALIFORNIA
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
HI. MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
REYNAGA, AND I'M COMING. I READ
RESIDENT UNITED NETWORK. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BUENOS LÀ
REPRESENT ALL ORGANIZATION
PROMOTORAS DE SALUD MENTAL
EVENING. MONOPOLIO DEL BEALL.
23-14 TYPEKIT. GRACIAS. THANK
YOU. BUENOS TARDES. MY NAME IS
JUANA TREJO. IS A PROMOTORA DE
SALUD DEL CONDADO DE ORANGE. Â.
ESTOY AQUI EN ESTA PROPUESTA.
GRACIAS. THANK YOU. HI. MY NAME
IS SARAH JOHNSON. WITH MUTUAL
HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND RESIDENT
UNITED NETWORK IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HI. MY NAME IS AMINA
PHINEAS. I'M HERE REPRESENTING
RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NAYHA SAJJU.
ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY. PROUD
CO-SPONSOR AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, CATHERINE CHARLES, ON
BEHALF OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANDREW
DAWSON, THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. BENJAMIN COHEN OF MOUNTAIN
VIEW, CALIFORNIA. SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NO ONE ELSE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT, LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 2347, PLEASE APPROACH, GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, KAREEM DRISSI ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE, WE DO
WANT TO SINCERELY ACKNOWLEDGE
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE AUTHOR,
THE WORK OF HIS STAFF,
TREMENDOUS STAFF, AS WELL AS THE
WORK OF THE SPONSOR.
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS IS A MEASURE
WHERE WE HAVE TO RESPECTFULLY
AGREE TO DISAGREE. SO WE REMAIN
IN OPPOSITION. BUT WE SINCERELY
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON OTHER LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE APPROACH.
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING,
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NONE.
IS THERE A MOTION, SENATOR
RUSSELL? SENATOR RUSSELL MOVES
THE BILL. ARCHULETA. HE DID. YOU
DID ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS,
RIGHT? YES, YES. OKAY, GREAT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO. DEFINITELY. SHE
DEFINITELY MOVED IT. SENATOR
RUSSELL DEFINITELY MOVED THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KARO, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FINAL ITEM 34 AB 2347.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED.
BURKE. BURKE I WILK NÓ WILK. NO.
ALLEN. ASHBY. ASHBY. I
CABALLERO. TO RUSSELL. TO
RUSSELL I LAIRD. LAIRD I NEELO.
NEELO. NO. WRATH. STERN WAHAB. 4
TO 2. 4 TO 2. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
PUT THAT ON CALL NEXT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA, ITEM 35 AB 2602.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, AB 2602
WOULD REQUIRE A PERFORMERS
INFORMED CONSENT AND PROPER
REPRESENTATION WHEN EXECUTING A
CONTRACT FOR ANY TRANSFER OF
RIGHTS TO THAT INDIVIDUAL'S
LIKENESS OR VOICE AMIDST THE
RISE OF THE DIGITAL AGE,
PERFORMERS ACROSS THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY HAVE
INADVERTENTLY BEEN SIGNING AWAY
THEIR RIGHTS TO THEIR DIGITAL
SELVES THROUGH CLAUSES THAT CAN
LOOK LIKE STANDARD COPYRIGHT
LANGUAGE. SPECIFICALLY,
INDIVIDUALS ARE UNKNOWINGLY
AUTHORIZING STUDIOS TO USE THEIR
VOICE AND LIKENESS IN ALL MEDIA
BY ALL CURRENT AND FUTURE
TECHNOLOGIES. IN PERPETUITY, AND
WITH NO ADDITIONAL COMPENSATION.
AB 2602 STRIKES THE BALANCE
BETWEEN INDUSTRY PROGRESS AND
PROTECTING A PERFORMER'S RIGHTS
TO THEIR DIGITAL, SELF AND
LIVELIHOOD. THIS BILL DOES NOT
OUTRIGHT PROHIBIT THE USE OF
DIGITAL REPLICAS, BUT RATHER
ENSURES THAT IF PERFORMERS AGREE
TO LICENSE OUT THEIR DIGITAL
SELF, THAT THEY ARE FULLY AWARE
OF THE EXTENT OF AND THE
INTENTIONS FOR THAT USE. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE MOTION
PICTURES ASSOCIATION AND
RECORDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OF AMERICA FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON AMENDMENTS THAT
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS. THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT, AND HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS SHANE GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF SAG-AFTRA AND ELMER
LIZARDI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION. GUSMAN. MR.
CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, SHANE GUSMAN, ON
BEHALF OF SAG-AFTRA AND OUR
160,000 PLUS PERFORMERS, THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY THAT CREATE CAN
CREATE A COPY OF YOUR VOICE OR
LIKENESS SUCH THAT THE PUBLIC
CAN'T REALLY TELL THAT IT'S NOT
YOU. IS IT? INCREDIBLY SCARY FOR
PERFORMERS? AND, THE TECHNOLOGY
IS GETTING CHEAPER. IT'S GETTING
BETTER AND EASIER TO USE, AND SO
WE BELIEVE AND WE THANK FOR THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR AUTHORING
THIS BILL, THAT WE NEED TO PUT
SOME GUARDRAILS AROUND IT. AS HE
SAID, WE'RE NOT PREVENTING THE
USE OF THIS TECHNOLOGY. WE'RE
JUST MAKING SURE THAT IT'S USED
IN A RESPONSIBLE WAY, THIS BILL
BASICALLY DEALS WITH INFORMED
CONSENT SO THAT THERE ISN'T
UNAUTHORIZED USE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY. AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
LON FERNANDEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION, A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF HB 2602, THE
ADVANCEMENT OF TECHNOLOGY SHOULD
BE TO THE BENEFIT, NOT THE
DETRIMENT OF WORKERS, AND SHOULD
BE USED NOT TO EXPLOIT DE-SKILL
OR ABUSE THEIR SKILLS. WE DO
BELIEVE THAT TECHNOLOGY CAN BE A
PRODUCTIVE TOOL WHEN USED TO
SUPPORT WORKERS, NOT WHEN USED
TO REPLACE THEM. THE GUARDRAILS
PUT IN PLACE FOR AB 2602 ARE A
MODEL ON HOW TO REGULATE THE USE
OF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IN
THE WORKPLACE TO ENSURE WORKERS
HAVE A REAL AND MEANINGFUL
OVERSIGHT ON HOW THIS TECHNOLOGY
IS USED BY EMPLOYERS. AB 2602
REQUIRES EMPLOYERS TO HAVE A
UNION OR LEGAL REPRESENTATION
WHEN ENTERING A CONTRACT THAT
ALLOWS A DIGITAL REPLICA OF
THEIR VOICE OR LIKENESS AS A
TOOL IN THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY, I CAN SUPPORT A
PLETHORA OF WORKERS AND
PERFORMERS IN A WIDE RANGE OF
PROJECTS, BOLSTERING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ACTORS ACROSS
THE INDUSTRY. HOWEVER THIS ONLY
HAPPENS WITH THESE WORKER
CENTERED GUARDRAILS AS THEY ARE
PUT IN PLACE TO ENSURE
PERFORMERS ARE AT THE CENTER OF
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS. AB
2602 WILL ADDRESS THE USE OF AI
IN THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY,
BUT THIS WORKER CENTERED CONCEPT
CAN BE APPLIED TO OTHER
INDUSTRIES IMPACTED BY EMERGING
AI TECHNOLOGIES. AND FOR THESE
REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OTHERS IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE, HI
AGAIN, TRACY ROSENBERG, OAKLAND
PRIVACY. WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHED
THE MICROPHONE. LET'S TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 2602, PLEASE
APPROACH SUPPORT. ACTUALLY,
BENJAMIN COHN OF MOUNTAIN VIEW
AGAIN. THANK YOU. OTHERS, OTHERS
IN SUPPORT SEEING NO ONE ELSE,
LET'S TURN TO OPPOSITION.
OPPOSITION TO FILE NUMBER I'M
SORRY, 35 AB 2602 SEEING NO
OPPOSITION. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
IS THERE A MOTION? SENATOR WILK
MOVES THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I'D LIKE TO
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
35 AB 2602. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
UMBERG Ã. UMBERG. AYE. WILK
AYE. WILK AYE. ALLEN A ALLEN.
AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE
CABALLERO. TWO. RUSSELL. TWO.
RUSSELL. AYE LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE.
NEELO NHIÀU. AYE. ROTH. ROTH
AYE. STERN. WAHAB THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. 8 TO 0 EIGHT ZERO. WE'LL
PUT THAT ON CALL. ALL RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA, OUR
FAVORITE BILL COMING UP RIGHT
NOW. YES. AB 3279. THE BILL.
THIS IS THE ANNUAL BILL
AUTHORIZING THE LICENSING FEE TO
BE COLLECTED FROM CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS TO FUND THE STATE BAR.
AND LET ME BEGIN BY SAYING THAT
NO COMMITTEE WANTS TO AUTHORIZE
A FEE INCREASE. AND WHILE THE
RANK AND FILE, STAFF AT THE BAR
DESERVE TO BE FAIRLY COMPENSATED
, IT FEELS A LITTLE UNFAIR TO
THE LEGISLATURE TO HAVE TO HAVE
THESE CIVIL SERVICE JOBS USED AS
ANY FORM OF LEVERAGE BY STATE
BAR LEADERSHIP TO DEMAND A FEE
INCREASE. HOWEVER THE BILL DOES
REPRESENT THIS COMMITTEE'S
COMMITMENT TO HONOR THE HARD
WORKING STAFF OF THE STATE BAR
AND PROTECT THEM FROM POTENTIAL
LAYOFFS. TO THAT END, THIS BILL
PROPOSES TO AUTHORIZE A FEE
INCREASE OF $88 FOR ACTIVE
ATTORNEYS AND NEARLY $24 FOR
INACTIVE ATTORNEYS. THE MORE
THAN HALF OF THIS FEE INCREASE,
$52 OF THE 88 FOR ACTIVE LICENSE
FEES, WILL DIRECTLY GO TO
FUNDING STAFF SALARIES, AND
CANNOT BE USED FOR ANY OTHER
PURPOSE. ANOTHER $11 GOES TO
FUND TWO PROACTIVE DISCIPLINARY
PROGRAMS, A DIVERSION FUND FOR
FIRST TIME LOW LEVEL OFFENDERS
OF THE RULES OF PROFESSIONAL
CONDUCT THAT MAY CUT THE STATE
BAR'S DISCIPLINARY WORKLOAD BY
20, AND AN INNOVATIVE CLIENT
TRUST FUND MONITORING PROGRAM TO
PROACTIVELY ENSURE A SCANDAL
LIKE THE ONE WE ALL SAW
INVOLVING TOM GIRARDI NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN. THE FEE LEVEL
PROPOSED BY THIS BILL IS ONLY
ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF WHAT THE
STATE BAR REQUESTED, AND
REPRESENTS AN AMOUNT JUSTIFIABLE
BY THE STATE BAR'S ACTUAL NEEDS.
AGAIN, I STAND COMMITTED TO
PROTECTING THE STATE BAR'S
WORKFORCE WHILE ENSURING THE
PRUDENT USE OF RESOURCES. THIS
IS WHY THE FEE INCREASE PROPOSED
BY THIS BILL COMES WITH
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET CONTROL
LANGUAGE TO LIMIT THE STATE
BAR'S DISCRETION AND HOW THESE
FUNDS COULD BE SPENT. IN
CLOSING, I WILL NOTE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE, THAT NEITHER OF THESE
COMMITTEES ARE FISCAL. HER
BUDGET IS NOT A FISCAL OR BUDGET
COMMITTEE. SO TRYING TO GRAPPLE
WITH THE STATE BAR REQUESTS,
ROUTINELY DEMONSTRATES WHY THIS
AGENCY MUST MOVE INTO THE NORMAL
BUDGET PROCESS, IN MY OPINION. I
HOPE THIS YEAR'S BILL AND FEE
PROPOSAL HELPS JUMPSTART
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE GOVERNOR
AND THE JUDICIAL BRANCH TO HELP
US IN THAT EFFORT. THIS BILL
DOES NOT HAVE ANY FORMAL
SUPPORT, BUT THE STATE BAR IS
HERE IF MEMBERS HAVE THOUGHTS OR
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA. CHAIR KALRA, AND I'M TOLD
THAT ASSEMBLY PRIVACY IS WAITING
FOR ME, SO I'M GOING TO EXERCISE
CHAIR'S PREROGATIVE TO MAKE A
FEW COMMENTS BEFORE BEFORE I
LEAVE. AND THEN I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO SENATOR WILK, FIRST OF
ALL, TO I EXPECT THAT YOUR FOLKS
ARE GOING TO TESTIFY, MISS
WILSON AND MR. STALLINGS, THANK
YOU, WE'VE HAD, A JOURNEY
TOGETHER. AND THIS JOURNEY HAS
BEEN, MADE MORE CHALLENGING BY
MR. GIRARDI AND SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT THAT'S EXPOSED
WITHIN THE STATE BAR. I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE STEPS THAT HAVE
BEEN TAKEN OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS TO INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND DISCIPLINE. I BELIEVE WE'RE
STILL GOING TO HAVE SOME
OVERSIGHT WITH RESPECT TO
ACCOUNTABILITY AND DISCIPLINE.
WE SHARE RESPONSIBILITY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT. WITH
RESPECT TO THE BAR, I THINK THE
SUPREME COURT ACTUALLY HAS
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY, BUT WE
EXERCISE OUR OVERSIGHT NOW AND
AGAIN. THERE ARE STILL SOME
CHALLENGES TO BE MET, I AM A
MAGNET FOR, COMMENTS AND
CONCERNS CONCERNING THE STATE
BAR, I AM STILL A PRACTICING
LAWYER, ALTHOUGH MY PARTNERS
PROBABLY DON'T AGREE WITH THAT,
BUT I BUT I KNOW THAT YOU'VE
WORKED HARD TO BASICALLY MEET
SOME OF THOSE OBSTACLES THAT
HAVE BEEN PRESENTED. AND SO
ESPECIALLY TO YOU, MR.
STALLINGS, I KNOW THAT THAT YOU
ARE BASICALLY A, YOU KNOW, FULL
TIME VOLUNTEER, PRETTY MUCH YOUR
YOUR SALARY SHOULD BE TRIPLED,
WHICH, BY THE WAY, IS ZERO IN
ANY EVENT, IN ANY EVENT, SO I
WANTED TO MAKE THOSE COMMENTS
BEFORE I HAVE TO DEPART AND TURN
THIS OVER TO SENATOR WILK. THANK
YOU, COMMITTEE MEMBERS, FOR
INDULGING THAT. SENATOR WILK,
THERE YOU GO. THAT SUPPORT
POSITION FOR ME. I WILL VOTE AYE
WHEN I RETURN. YES, THAT'S
CORRECT. OKAY. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND IF I HEARD CORRECTLY,
YOU'RE JUST HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. CORRECT. OR DO YOU
WANT TO COMMENT? I CAN COMMENT.
OH, YOU MAY. THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS BRANDON STALLINGS. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BRANDON STALLINGS.
I'M THE SUPREME COURT APPOINTEE.
I STILL CAN'T HEAR YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THERE YOU GO. NO SOUND
LIKE GOD. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON, EVERYONE. MY NAME IS
BRANDON STALLINGS. I'M THE CHAIR
OF THE STATE BAR OF CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO THANK CHAIR UMBERG FOR
HIS COMMENTS. ALSO FOR, CHAIR
KALRA FOR HIS WORK ON THE BILL
THIS YEAR. I THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP AND WORKING
WITH THE STATE BAR, ALONG WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT, ON
SOME OF THE REFORMS THAT, CHAIR
JUST TALKED ABOUT, THESE, THIS
WORK RELATES TO REFORMS,
OVERSIGHT AND PUBLIC PROTECTION
ACTIONS IN RECENT YEARS THAT
HAVE MADE US MORE EFFECTIVE,
FOCUSED AND TRANSPARENT AND AN
ACCOUNTABLE AGENCY TO BOTH
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY. IT'S
BECAUSE OF THIS PARTNERSHIP,
HARD WORK AND GROWING TRUST THAT
WE ARE HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB 3279. THE STATE BAR
IDENTIFIED THE NEED FOR THAT
$125 INCREASE IN ATTORNEY
LICENSING FEES, 95 OF WHICH WAS
TO MAINTAIN EXISTING OPERATIONS
AND SERVICES TO KEEP THE LIGHTS
ON, AND $30 TO IMPROVE PUBLIC
PROTECTION. THIS BILL GOES A
LONG WAY TO HELPING US GET
THERE. AB 3279 PROTECTS ALL
CURRENT EMPLOYEES WHILE
ANTICIPATING THAT THE STATE BAR
WILL DOUBLE ITS VACANCY RATE BY
APRIL 2027. WE ARE UP FOR THAT
CHALLENGE, BUT DO NEED TO MAKE
NECESSARY TECHNOLOGICAL
INVESTMENTS TO ENABLE US TO
SUSTAIN THAT HEADCOUNT REDUCTION
WITHOUT NEGATIVELY IMPACTING
SERVICE LEVELS FOR OUR REMAINING
EMPLOYEES. TO THAT END, THE
STATE BAR IS SEEKING
AUTHORIZATION TO ACCESS EITHER
THROUGH TRANSFER OR LOAN FUNDS
FROM THE CLIENT SECURITY FUND TO
SUPPORT NEEDED IT INVESTMENT. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEES TO
IDENTIFY A PATH FORWARD ON THE
IT INVESTMENT ISSUE OVER THE
COMING WEEKS, AS MENTIONED, AB
3279 ALSO INCLUDES INCLUDES A
SMALL INCREASE TO SUPPORT A
DIVERSION PROGRAM. LOW RISK
MISCONDUCT MATTERS, AND AN AUDIT
AND REVIEW PROGRAM TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC FROM MISAPPROPRIATION
AND MISUSE OF CLIENT TRUST
ACCOUNTS. WITH THE FEE INCREASE
CURRENTLY INCLUDED IN THE BILL.
AND IF, IF THERE'S AN AMENDMENT
THAT ALLOWS US THE AUTHORITY TO
USE RESERVES FOR I.T.
INVESTMENTS, WE'VE REQUESTED TO
COMPENSATE FOR STAFF REDUCTIONS
AND MODERNIZE OUR SERVICE TO THE
PUBLIC. WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT
WHAT THE FUTURE HOLDS FOR THE
STATE BAR. THANK YOU. AND WE ARE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NOT TOO BAD. 215 ARE
YOU SPEAKING? YOU JUST HERE FOR
TECHNICAL ANYBODY ELSE KIND OF
DANGEROUS WITH THIS? ANYBODY
ELSE IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME UP
IN OPPOSITION WHEN YOU'RE READY
FOR IT. WELL, I'M DOING SUPPORT
FIRST AND THEN WE'LL DO
OPPOSITION. OKAY. SEEING NO ONE
HERE SUPPORTING ATTORNEYS. DO WE
HAVE PRIMARY. DO WE HAVE
PRIMARY. DO WE HAVE PRIMARY.
HOLD IT BECAUSE YOU'RE JUST A ME
TOO. RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ARE YOU.
OH, YOU'RE GOING TO BE THE
PRIMARY OKAY. GOOD. I'M JUST
STEPPING IN. GO AHEAD AND COME
UP HERE IF YOU LIKE. OR THERE,
WHEREVER YOU'RE COMFORTABLE. I
AM REQUESTING AMENDMENTS. THESE
AMENDMENTS SHOULD NOT BE NEW. I
REQUESTED THEM ON THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE, BUT IT WAS PROCEDURALLY
TOO LATE AT THAT POINT, I GUESS
TO BEFORE IT HAD TO GO TO THE
SENATE. I HAVE SPOKEN WITH STAFF
FOR BOTH COMMITTEES ABOUT THE
NEED TO CODIFY A FLOOR OF
TESTING ACCOMMODATION
PROCEDURES. RIGHT NOW, THE STATE
BAR HAS TAKEN THE POSITION THAT
NO CALIFORNIA CIVIL RIGHTS LAW
APPLIES TO IT, AND THEY HAVE
BEEN CHALLENGING THE FEDERAL,
DISABILITY LAWS. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT IT IS NOT LEFT ENTIRELY TO
THE DISCRETION OF THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT. THAT COURT HAS
HELD THAT BOTH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE COURT HAVE AUTHORITY TO
SET, RULES REGULATING ADMISSION
TO THE STATE BAR, AND THERE
SHOULD BE A FLOOR SET, BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN STATUTE IN THIS
BILL TO ENSURE THAT DISABLED
APPLICANTS HAVE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY ON THE BAR EXAM,
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
GETTING DECISIONS TIMELY TO BE
HEARD ON ADMINISTRATIVE APPEALS
AND JUDICIAL REVIEW, AND TO HAVE
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE BAR
PREP INVESTMENT DECISIONS ABOUT
THEIR ACCOMMODATIONS. THEY
SHOULD HAVE A HEARING, IF THEY
HAVE AN APPEAL THAT IS NOT
GRANTED ON THE PAPERS, THERE IS
A HEARING FOR CHAPTER SIX,
ACCUSATIONS AND MORAL CHARACTER
DETERMINATIONS THAT APPLY TO ALL
APPLICANTS, BUT NOT TO SOMETHING
SIMILARLY CONTROLLING AND ACCESS
TO THE PROFESSION FOR DISABLED
APPLICANTS, THE THEY HAVE
CURRENTLY BAN INDIVIDUALIZED
CONSIDERATION OF CERTAIN
ACCOMMODATIONS WITH NO SHOWING
THAT IT'S FUNDAMENTAL ALTERATION
OR UNDUE BURDEN, WHICH ARE THE
ONLY EXCEPTIONS TO SUCH
INDIVIDUALIZED CONSIDERATION.
UNDER FEDERAL LAW. AND ALL OF
THOSE THINGS SHOULD BE CODIFIED
INTO STATUTE AMONG OTHER THINGS.
YOU HAVE MY PROPOSALS, OR AT
LEAST YOUR STAFF DOES, BEFORE
THIS IS FINALIZED. THE SUPREME
COURT MAY CHOOSE TO GO ABOVE IT.
THERE IS A RULES REVISION, BUT
YOU SHOULD SET THAT FLOOR. IT'S
NOT A QUESTION OF WHETHER A
PARTICULAR APPLICANT IS ADMITTED
OR WHAT THE ADMISSION
REQUIREMENTS ARE. SO IT'S NOT IN
THEIR EXCLUSIVE SEPARATION OF
POWERS JURISDICTION, THIS SHOULD
BE DONE. IT'S BELATED, PEOPLE
ARE GETTING HOSPITALIZED. THE
LAST EXAM CYCLE BECAUSE OF THE
DISPARATE TREATMENT INVOLVED AND
THE ACCOMMODATION PROCEDURES,
FOR THE CAL PALACE, I URGE YOU
TO DO THAT. THANK YOU. SO YOU'RE
OPPOSED? UNLESS AMENDED. THANK
YOU. ANYBODY ELSE SPEAKING?
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. LET'S
PULL IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS CONCERNS.
WELL SENATOR ALLEN, I DON'T KNOW
IF THE AUTHOR OR THE FOLKS IN
THE BAR WANT TO ANSWER SOME OF
THE CONCERNS. THANK YOU. SENATOR
YES. INCLUDED IN THE BILL DUE TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED. IS IN ORDER TO MONITOR
THE ISSUE AND RECEIVE MORE DATA,
THE BILL DOES REQUIRE THE STATE
BAR TO SUBMIT SPECIFIED DATA
REGARDING ACTS RELATED
COMPLAINTS TO THE COMMITTEE. AND
ONCE WE GET THAT DATA, THEN WE
CAN FOLLOW UP AND ACTUALLY TRY
TO CREATE POLICIES THAT ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS. BUT
DEFINITELY HEARING IT AND WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THE
APPROPRIATE DATA. SO THAT WE CAN
RESPOND EITHER LEGISLATIVELY OR
THE STATE BAR CAN ADOPT POLICIES
THAT REFLECT THE NEEDS OF THOSE
OF THAT COMMUNITY. OKAY. THANK
YOU. AND THANK YOU. CAN I HAVE A
MOTION? MOTION BY SENATOR LAIRD,
AND THEN I'LL ALLOW YOU CLOSE
WHEN I DO MY FOLLOWING, MY
CLOSING COMMENTS. I'M ASSUMING
WITH THIS INCREASE THAT YOU GUYS
ARE NOT GOING TO BE IN NEXT
SEASON'S STORY ARC OF,
HOUSEWIVES OF BEVERLY HILLS, I
GOT THAT COMMITMENT. YOU KNOW,
I'LL JUST LIKE I TELL ALL ALL
THE VICTIMS THAT I WORK WITH,
I'LL NEVER GUARANTEE RESULTS,
BUT I PROMISE TO WORK AS HARD AS
POSSIBLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
RIGHT THING HAPPENS. SO THAT'S
MY COMMITMENT. AND I AM
CONFIDENT THAT, YOU MAY CLOSE,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. YOU KNOW,
AGAIN, I'M NOT THRILLED AT THE
PROSPECT OF INCREASING MY OWN
FEES, BUT THE REALITY IS THAT IF
WE DON'T APPROVE THIS MEASURE
TODAY, THE STATE SUPREME COURT
WILL BE FORCED TO SET THE
LICENSING FEE, AND THERE WILL BE
NO PROTECTIONS AGAINST A LARGER
FEE INCREASE OR LIMITS AS TO HOW
THE BAR MAY SPEND THIS REVENUE.
SO WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM 37 AB 3279. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS UMBERG WILK ALLEN.
HI. SORRY ABOUT THAT. ALLEN I
WILK I YES, MA'AM. ASHBY. Ã
ASHBY. AYE CABALLERO. DURAZO
CARUSO. AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE
NILO. NILO. AYE. ROTH. ROTH.
AYE. STERN WAHAB. 7 TO 0. ALL
RIGHT. 7 TO 0. WE WILL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL FOR OUR COLLEAGUES.
UP NEXT. I KNOW ASSEMBLYWOMAN
IRWIN. SO THIS IS FILE ITEM 42
AB 2723. DO PASS. WELL, GOOD
AFTERNOON. DO PASS, AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. AND WITH
THAT, WHENEVER YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE, YOU MAY START. GOOD
AFTERNOON, VICE CHAIR AND
SENATORS. I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
2723, WHICH PROVIDES UPDATES TO
THE CRADLE TO CAREER DATA
SYSTEM, REFERRED TO AS CðC. I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED WITH CTC SINCE ITS
INCEPTION IN THE STATE BUDGET,
AND CURRENTLY SERVE AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON THE GOVERNING
BOARD. WITH SENATOR LAIRD, I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT FOR THE
COMMITTEE THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING A LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM LINKING EXISTING
EDUCATION WORKFORCE, FINANCIAL
AID AND SOCIAL SERVICE
INFORMATION. THIS SYSTEM WILL
ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO ANSWER KEY
QUESTIONS ABOUT EQUITY, WHILE
ALLOWING US TO ADDRESS
DISPARITIES IN OPPORTUNITY AND
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS, UNFORTUNATELY, IN
THIS SPACE, CALIFORNIA HAS NOT
BEEN THE LEADER, BUT ONE OF THE
LAST STATES TO STAND UP A
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM,
MEANING WE ARE CATCHING UP, BUT
BY NO MEANS BREAKING NEW GROUND.
THANKFULLY, CTC CELEBRATED ITS
FIRST ROUND OF DATA SUBMISSIONS
FROM DATA PROVIDERS LAST FALL
AND ANTICIPATES MAKING ITS FIRST
ANALYTICAL TOOLS, DATA
DASHBOARDS AVAILABLE LATER THIS
YEAR. AS WITH ANY MATURING STATE
ENTITY, THERE ARE ASPECTS OF ITS
GOVERNING STATUTE THAT WOULD
BENEFIT FROM A REFINEMENT, WHICH
IS WHAT THIS BILL SEEKS TO DO,
THE THIS BILL ALSO CLARIFIES THE
ROLE CðC HOLDS IN RELATION TO
THE DATA THEY MAINTAIN ON BEHALF
OF THE DATA PROVIDERS, AND
REINFORCES HOW CTC WORKS WITH
THE INFORMATION PRACTICES ACT.
WHEN THE DATA SYSTEM WAS
CRAFTED, THE STRUCTURE WAS
THOUGHTFULLY. WHEN IT WAS
CREATED, THE STRUCTURE WAS
THOUGHTFULLY CRAFTED TO ENSURE
DATA PROVIDERS WOULD WILLINGLY
PARTICIPATE. THIS IMPORTANTLY
MEANT THAT DATA PROVIDERS WOULD
RETAIN OWNERSHIP AND CONTROL
OVER THEIR SOURCE DATA. IT ALSO
MEANS THAT CTC WAS NOT GRANTED
ANY AUTHORITY TO DIRECT OR
DEMAND ANY ACTION BY THE DATA
PROVIDERS. THESE STRUCTURAL
LIMITATIONS PROVIDE A BARRIER TO
CTC, HONORING THE IMPORTANT
RIGHTS PROVIDED BY CALIFORNIANS
AND THE INFORMATION PRIVACY ACT.
THIS MAKES DIRECTING
CALIFORNIA'S TO DATA. THIS MEANS
DIRECTING CALIFORNIANS TO THE
DATA PROVIDERS WHO DO NOT, FACE
THE SAME BARRIERS AND
APPROPRIATE SOLUTION TO HONOR
THESE RIGHTS. AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS ON PAGE TEN, I HAVE
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, AND WITH ME TODAY, I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES, ERIC FLORES,
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
OFFICE OF CRADLE TO CAREER, AND
RAQUEL MORALES MORALES, POLICY
AND GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
ASSOCIATE FOR TRUST WEST. YOU
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ERIC FLORES WITH THE
OFFICE OF CRADLE TO CAREER HERE
TO OFFER ANY TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
OR ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MEMBERS. RAQUEL
MORALES, ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST, WE ARE A
RESEARCH ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
COMMITTED TO ADVANCING POLICIES
AND PRACTICES THAT DISMANTLE THE
RACIAL AND ECONOMIC BARRIERS AND
BETTER THAN THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION, EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
WE'RE EXCITED FOR THIS LONG
OVERDUE STATEWIDE LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM THAT CAN PROVIDE
CROSS-SECTOR DATA ON EDUCATION
AND WORKFORCE TO GIVE
STAKEHOLDERS INSIGHT INTO
STUDENT OUTCOMES AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT, PUT SIMPLY, CðC HAS
THE POWER TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
TOOL FOR IMPROVING RACIAL AND
SOCIOECONOMIC JUSTICE IN
CALIFORNIA'S INSTITUTIONS. FROM
A CHILD'S EARLIEST YEARS, ALL
THE WAY TO A STUDENT'S
EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY INTO COLLEGE
AND CAREER AT TRUST WEST.
STRONGLY BELIEVES THAT A DATA
SYSTEM MUST BE CENTERED ON
ACHIEVING EQUITY AND THE NEEDS
OF STUDENTS, PARENTS, AND
FAMILIES. SINCE THE INCEPTION OF
THE WORK IN 2019, THERE HAVE
BEEN A HIGH LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT,
TRANSPARENCY AND COLLABORATION
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS, THE
OFFICE HAS CONTINUOUSLY ENGAGED
STAKEHOLDERS FROM PUBLIC
MEETINGS, COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT,
EVENTS AND CONTINUOUS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC INPUT.
THE TOOLS DEVELOPED UNDER THE
SYSTEM WILL ALLOW FAMILIES,
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITIES TO
ACCESS DATA THAT CAN SUPPORT
THEM WITH MAKING INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR EDUCATION
AND FUTURES. SIMILARLY,
ADVOCATES AND DECISION MAKERS
SUCH AS YOURSELVES WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO UP TO DATE DATA THAT
CAN SUPPORT WITH IDENTIFYING
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS, CRAFTING
POLICIES, AND TARGETING STATE
INVESTMENTS. AB 2723 WILL ALLOW
CTC TO FULFILL ITS STATUTORY
OBLIGATIONS, BUT OF RELEASING
PUBLIC FACING TOOLS WHILE
MAINTAINING DATA SECURITY AND
PRIVACY. THIS LEGISLATION IS
CRITICAL AS IT ALLOWS THEM TO
EXECUTE THEIR INTENDED ROLE AS
STEWARDS OF THE DATA THAT THE
STATE AGENCIES COLLECT AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THE DATA SYSTEM.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO TAKE THIS TIME
TO THANK BOTH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN AND THE OFFICE OF CRADLE
TO CAREER FOR THE DILIGENT
ATTENTION TO DATA SECURITY AND
PRIVACY IN THIS WORK. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. GREAT. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT, PLEASE COME
UP AND ADD YOUR ME TWO
TESTIMONY. GOOD AFTERNOON. AND
ALVARADO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EDGE COALITION AND
SUPPORT, THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. ALLOW ME, ON BEHALF
OF CAL CHAMBER AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION? ARE YOU ARE
YOU PRIMARY? ALL RIGHT. GREAT.
YEAH. COME ON UP.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. TWO
MINUTES. GO AHEAD. HI, EVERYONE.
TRACY ROSENBERG FROM OAKLAND.
PRIVACY WE ARE HERE WITH
CONCERNS ABOUT AB 2723. THE
BASIC RIGHTS PROVIDED UNDER THE
INFORMATION PRACTICES ACT WERE
BROADLY INTENDED TO TOUCH ALL
ASPECTS OF STATE ACTIVITIES AND
OPERATIONALIZE THE PRIVACY
PROTECTION CLAUSE IN THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION. CTC IS
A LARGE SCALE WAREHOUSING OF
CALIFORNIA PUPILS PERSONAL
INFORMATION UNDER THE AUSPICES
OF A 21 PERSON GOVERNING BOARD
AND HOUSED IN THE STATE'S
GOVERNMENTAL OPERATIONS OFFICE.
THE CTC IS NOT, IN FACT, DATA
MAINTAINERS. THEY WILL BE
UTILIZING THE DATA FOR ANALYSIS
AND EVALUATION AND SHARING IT
WITH POLICYMAKERS AND ADVOCATES.
CAN RESEARCHERS, PER THEIR OWN
WEBSITE. AND THAT IS OWNING AND
USING THE DATA, NOT SIMPLY SORT
OF MAINTAINING IT IN A DATA
REFRIGERATOR. WE'RE CONCERNED
THE BILL IS ATTEMPTING TO SHIFT
PRIVACY RIGHTS GUARANTEED BY THE
STATE, AT LEAST SOMETIMES, TO
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES THAT
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO THE IPA. AND
WE'RE OPEN TO CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
FOR DEALING WITH ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN, BUT NOT SIMPLY EXEMPTING
HUMONGOUS, YOU KNOW, STATE DATA
PROJECTS FROM THE IPA AS A
WHOLE. IF WE DO THIS, THIS WILL
NOT BE THE FIRST. AND THEN
SOONER OR LATER WE WON'T HAVE AN
IPA AT ALL. SO WE ASK YOU TO
LOOK FOR DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS AS
A PRIVACY GROUP. YOU KNOW, WE'VE
HAD 5000 CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR ABOUT WHAT A
BURDEN PRIVACY LAWS ARE. AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY CAN BE, BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE SIMPLY
EXEMPT OURSELVES FROM THEM. SO
WE DON'T THINK THIS IS A GOOD
PRECEDENT AND IT'S NOT THE RIGHT
ANSWER TO WHATEVER PROBLEM WE'RE
WE ARE PERCEIVING WITH COMPLYING
WITH THE IPA. THAT'S ALL. THANKS
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION ME TO CUT A WHOLE
SHEET THERE? I WILL BE QUICK, I
PROMISE. MY NAME IS OR. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE. SORRY, MY
NAME IS LEAH JONES ON BEHALF OF
A VOICE FOR CHOICE ADVOCACY,
UNFORTUNATELY, WE ARE REQUESTING
THAT THIS BILL BE AMENDED TODAY
OR WE OPPOSE SPECIFICALLY, WE'RE
OPPOSED TO NO INDIVIDUAL HAVING
THE RIGHT TO INQUIRE NOR BE
NOTIFIED AS TO WHETHER THE DATA
SYSTEM MAINTAINS A RECORD ABOUT
THEM, NOR THEIR CHILD, AND THEY
CANNOT INSPECT PII PERSONAL
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION IN ANY
RECORD MAINTAINED IN THE DATA
SYSTEM. MOST OTHER SIMILAR
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT DATABASES,
LIKE CARE AND THE NEWBORN
SCREENING REGISTRY ALLOW YOU TO
SUBMIT A FORM WITH PROOF OF
IDENTITY TO REQUEST A DOWNLOAD
OF WHETHER THERE IS ANY DATA
PERTAINING TO YOURSELF OR YOUR
CHILD, AND WHAT THAT DATA IS
WITHIN. SORRY, WITHIN C2C'S
FIRST LEGISLATOR REPORTED
DECEMBER 2020 C2C'S VERY OWN
LEGAL SUBCOMMITTEE ALSO
RECOMMENDED THE OPT OUT POLICY
AND EVEN DRAFTED A FORM FOR SUCH
. BEFORE PASSING OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE, WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT AB 2723 BE FURTHER
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE TWO
SECTIONS THAT REMOVE
TRANSPARENCY COMPLETELY AND ALSO
ADD BACK IN AND OPT OUT OPTION.
SO EVERY INDIVIDUAL IN
CALIFORNIA REMAINS INFORMED
ABOUT WHAT PII IS BEING
COLLECTED BY CðC AND HAS THE
OPTION TO OPT OUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GREAT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE, PULL IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. SENATOR LAIRD, THANK
YOU, JUST TO COMMENT, I
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION. AND
AS WAS MENTIONED IN THE OPENING
STATEMENT, I'M THE SENATE'S
REPRESENTATIVE TO THE BOARD OF
CRADLE TO CAREER. AND THE REAL
IDEA HERE IS TO BE THIS
COMPREHENSIVE DATABASE OF MANY
OTHER PLACES THAT COLLECT
INFORMATION ON WHICH WE CAN MAKE
DECISIONS. AND THE CRADLE TO
CAREER ITSELF DOES NOT HAVE THE
INDEPENDENT ABILITY TO CHECK,
THE IDENTITY. AND BESIDES, IF
THERE'S A NEW DATA DUMP, IT WILL
JUST OVERRIDE IT AND YET WHEN
SOME OF THE ONES THAT ARE AT
ISSUE IN THE TESTIMONY, PEOPLE
HAVE A RIGHT TO AMEND IT OR OPT
OUT OR DO THINGS WITH THOSE
INDIVIDUAL DATABASES. AND SO THE
IMPORTANT THING IS, IS TO
PROTECT THAT RIGHT, TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE KNOW AND THEY DO IT
BECAUSE IT IS NOT AN EASY
MECHANISM OR EVEN A POSSIBLE ONE
TO ENFORCE AT THE CRADLE TO
CAREER LEVEL. SO I THINK THIS
BILL RESOLVES THE PROBLEM. AND
IF WE ALL HAVE TO COLLECTIVELY
WORK TO EDUCATE PEOPLE MORE
ABOUT WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE
ABOUT, THE PRIMARY UNDERLYING
DATABASES, DIDN'T THAT SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO DO AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD MOVE
THE BILL, SAY THAT SOUND LIKE A
MOTION TO ME. ANYBODY ELSE
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS? WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR LAIRD
THAT SOUNDED LIKE THE CLOSE
THERE. AND THAT SOUNDS LIKE A
CLOSE. SO WITH THAT SECRETARY,
LET'S PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS
IS FILE ITEM 42 AB 2723. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS NUMBER
WILK. Ã WILK I, ALAN ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. CABALLERO DURAZZO.
LAIRD. LAIRD AYE. NHIÀU. HI.
NEAL. AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
STERN. WAHAB 5 TO 0 5 TO 0.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, VERY MUCH. AND SENATOR.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN CARILLO,
CONGRATULATIONS. SO IF I READ
THIS CORRECTLY, YOU HAVE TWO
BILLS BEFORE US TODAY. FIRST ONE
IS FILE ITEM 53 AB 1950, WITH
THE RECOMMENDATION OF PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATE DO PASS,
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
AND WITH THAT, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS. I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH MY TEAM, IN
GETTING THIS ACROSS TODAY, I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT AB 1950, THE
CHÁVEZ ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. THIS
BILL ACKNOWLEDGES THE HISTORICAL
DISPLACEMENT OF THE PALO VERDE,
LA LOMA, AND MISSION COMMUNITIES
KNOWN TODAY AS CHAVEZ RAVINE.
THIS POLICY IS SPONSORED BY OUR
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER, RICARDO
LARA. AB. 1950 IS A CRITICAL
STEP FORWARD IN AIMS TO CORRECT
AN INJUSTICE THAT DISPLACED
FAMILIES AND HAS LINGERED IN THE
SHADOWS OF LOS ANGELES EAST SIDE
HISTORY FOR FAR TOO LONG. AMID
THE 1950S, THE VIBRANT
COMMUNITIES OF PALO VERDE, LA
LOMA AND BISHOP, OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS CHAVEZ RAVINE, WAS HOME TO
MOSTLY MEXICAN-AMERICAN FAMILIES
AS WELL AS ITALIAN AMERICAN
CHINESE AMERICANS. BUT THEY SAW
AN UPHEAVAL AS FAMILIES WERE
UPROOTED IN DISPLACED IN THE
NAME OF PROGRESS, FAMILIES WERE
PROMISED A RIGHT OF FIRST
REFUSAL TO BETTER HOUSING, BUT
INSTEAD THEY WERE LEFT
DESTITUTE. DURING THIS TIME, THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES EMPLOYED
VARIOUS TACTICS TO PRESSURE
HOMEOWNERS TO SELL THEIR
PROPERTIES, INCLUDING THE USE OF
EMINENT DOMAIN. FOR GENERATIONS,
CHAVEZ RAVINE STOOD AS A BEACON
OF HOPE AND RESILIENCE,
EMBODYING THE DAYDREAMS AND
ASPIRATIONS OF FAMILIES WHO
BUILT THEIR LIVES WITHIN ITS
EMBRACE. WITH THIS LEGISLATION,
WE ARE ADDRESSING THE PAST,
GIVING VOICE TO THIS INJUSTICE,
ACKNOWLEDGING THE PAIN OF THOSE
DISPLACED, OFFERING REPARATIVE
MEASURES AND ENSURES THAT WE
HONOR AND REMEMBER THE LEGACY OF
THESE THREE COMMUNITIES AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. I URGE YOU TO LEND
YOUR SUPPORT TO ESTABLISH THE
HEALING FOR THESE DESCENDANTS
WHO STILL LIVE WITHIN THESE
COMMUNITIES WITH ME TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS JOSEPHINE
FIGUEROA, DEPUTY COMMISSIONER OF
POLICY AND LEGISLATION TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. WELCOME. AND YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU, GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
JOSEPHINE FIGUEROA, DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER AND LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE UNDER THE LEADERSHIP
OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA. FIRST, I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CARRILLO FOR AUTHORING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE THROUGHOUT HIS
CAREER IN PUBLIC SERVICE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA HAS BEEN STEADFAST IN HIS
COMMITMENT TO SERVING THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES FROM
ADVOCATING FOR UNIVERSAL HEALTH
CARE TO CHAMPIONING
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IN THE
FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE.
COMMISSIONER LOTTA'S MISSION HAS
ALWAYS BEEN TO CONFRONT
HISTORICAL INJUSTICES AND FOSTER
A MORE EQUITABLE SOCIETY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THIS COMMITMENT
CONTINUES AS THE PROUD SPONSOR
OF AB 1950 WHAT WE SEEK TO
ADDRESS WITH AB 1950 IS
KNOWLEDGE, UNDERSTANDING AND
HEALING THE NEIGHBORHOODS OF
PALO VERDE, LA LOMA, AND BISHOP
IN THE LOS ANGELES SERVED AS
HAVENS FOR HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS SEEKING
HOUSING SECURITY AMIDST
SYSTEMATIC DISCRIMINATION. LONG
TIME RESIDENTS OF THESE
COMMUNITIES WERE NEVER FAIRLY
COMPENSATED FOR THEIR PROPERTY.
BOTH LAND OWNERS AND TENANTS,
MANY WHO HAVE LIVED THERE FOR
GENERATIONS, WERE COERCED INTO
LEAVING THEIR HOMES. ALTHOUGH
MANY RESISTED, ALL WERE
EVENTUALLY DISPLACED. WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BEGIN TO ADDRESS
THIS, AND WE SHOULD. THIS
LEGISLATION REPRESENTS A FIRST,
CRUCIAL STEP IN PROVIDING LONG
OVERDUE COMPENSATION TO THESE
RESIDENTS. IT ALSO OFFERS A PATH
TO RECONCILIATION AND HEALING
FOR ALL THOSE IMPACTED BY. BY
ADDRESSING PAST WRONGS. AB 1950
PAVES THE WAY FOR A MORE JUST
AND EQUITABLE LOS ANGELES. IT
WILL HELP EDUCATE ANGELENOS
ABOUT THE TRUE HISTORY OF WHAT
IS NOW KNOWN AS CHAVEZ RAVINE,
PROMOTING TRANSPARENCY AND
UNDERSTANDING, AB 1950 MARKS A
SIGNIFICANT MILESTONE IN THE
JOURNEY TOWARDS ACHIEVING
JUSTICE FOR THESE FAMILIES. ON
BEHALF OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA, I ASKED FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
ANY ME TOO. TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
BOB NAYLOR FOR FIELDSTEAD AND
COMPANY. THAT'S HOWARD AHMANSON
JR AND ORANGE COUNTY
PHILANTHROPY. PHILANTHROPIST
LONG DAY. THANK YOU SIR, WITH
THE MESA VERDE GROUP ON BEHALF
OF INCLUSIVE ACTION FOR THE CITY
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE MEASURE SEEING NONE, I'LL
PULL IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, CONCERNS.
SENATOR NILO. THIS HAPPENED A
LONG TIME AGO, AND I'M AWARE, BY
THE WAY, OF SOME PEOPLE,
PARTICULARLY OF MEXICAN DESCENT,
WHO REFUSED TO GO TO DODGER
GAMES BECAUSE OF THAT. BUT WHY
SOME PEOPLE WOULD SAY THIS IS A
LOCAL ISSUE, AND LOS ANGELES
OUGHT TO TAKE IT UP. IT'S BEEN A
WHILE. THEY HAVEN'T. WOULD YOU
CARE TO SPECULATE WHY? YOU KNOW,
I I'M NOT SURE WHY THE CITY HAS
NOT DECIDED TO MOVE ON. ANYTHING
ON THEIR OWN, BUT IT'S BEEN
DECADES IN THE MAKING AND THE
COMMUNITY HAS GATHERED FOR MANY
YEARS AND HAS BEEN DOING THE
WORK ON THE GROUND TO GET
ATTENTION AND REPRESENTATION AND
ACTUALLY HAVE A CONVERSATION.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES HAS YET
TO APOLOGIZE TO THESE FAMILIES
AND THEIR DESCENDANTS FOR
SELLING THEIR HOMES FOR LOWER
COST DURING THAT TIME, FOR WHAT
HAPPENED IN A POLITICAL ELECTION
IN WHICH A PRO-HOUSING MAYOR WAS
THEN, NOT DIDN'T WIN HIS
REELECTION AND Ã ALREADY FUNDED
HOUSING PROJECT THAT WAS MOVING
FORWARD DURING THE TRUMAN
ADMINISTRATION THAT HAD FEDERAL
FUNDING, WAS THEN REJECTED. AND
SO THE FAMILIES THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO MOVE INTO THAT
COMPLEX WEREN'T ABLE TO. AND SO
I'M JUST VERY PROUD TO HAVE
GROWN UP IN THIS COMMUNITY,
REPRESENT THIS COMMUNITY, AND
ACTUALLY START A CONVERSATION
THAT HAS YET TO TAKE PLACE
WITHIN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
THIS IS A SPECIFIC, APPLICATION.
IF YOU WILL, KIND OF BRADFORD'S
BILL THAT SETS UP THE
POSSIBILITY FOR, COMPENSATION
FOR, EMINENT DOMAIN, ISSUES THAT
WERE PURSUED UNJUSTLY AND I TOLD
SENATOR BRADFORD THAT, I WOULD
SUPPORT THAT LEGISLATION IF IT
HELD THE LOCAL COMMUNITY, IF IT
WAS A LOCAL COMMUNITY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE INJUSTICE.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS HE'S AMENDED
THE BILL SINCE, AND I'M HAPPY TO
HEAR THAT. BUT THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THIS IS DOING. AND SO I CAN
I CAN SUPPORT THIS. THANK YOU.
SO CAN I TAKE THAT AS A MOTION?
SURE. GREAT, SO BEFORE YOU
CLOSE, DEFINITELY, DEFINITELY
SUPPORT THE BILL. YOU KNOW, WHEN
IT COMES TO HISTORY, IT'S THE
WINNERS THAT WRITE HISTORY. BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THE HISTORY IS
TRUE. AND THERE WAS AN INJUSTICE
THERE. I AM REALLY SHOCKED,
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE COMPOSITION OF THIS CURRENT
LA CITY COUNCIL, THAT THEY'VE
NOT DONE ANYTHING. BUT AS YOU
SAID, HOPEFULLY THIS SPURS THEM
TO ACTION TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
AND WITH THAT, YOU MAY CLOSE. I
WILL TAKE YOUR STATEMENT AS MY
CLOSING. THANK YOU. SENATOR,
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
. VERY GOOD BILL. ITEM NUMBER 53
AB 1950. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. UMBERG. WILK. AYE.
WILK AYE. ALLEN ALLEN. AYE.
ASHBY ASHBY. AYE CABALLERO.
DURAZO LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE ANELLO.
AYE. MILO. AYE. ROTH ROTH. AYE.
STERN WAHAB. YOU HAVE 6 TO 0
WITH MEMBERS MISSING. ALL RIGHT.
SIX ZERO. AND WE WILL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR OUR COLLEAGUES TO ADD
ON. NOW WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
54 AB 2355. WAS THE
RECOMMENDATION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS OKAY. THE
RECOMMENDATION IS Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AND WITH THAT,
AS SOON AS YOU'VE GOT YOUR
PAPERS SHUFFLE SHUFFLED AND
YOU'RE READY, PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB
2355, WHICH WILL REQUIRE A
DISCLOSURE WHEN GENERATIVE AI IS
USED IN POLITICAL ADVERTISING TO
SUBSTANTIALLY ALTER EXISTING
MEDIA OR CREATE CONTENT THAT
WILL FALSELY APPEAR TO BE
AUTHENTIC TO A REASONABLE
PERSON, THE AVAILABILITY OF
TOOLS TO DOCTOR IMAGES, VIDEO
AND SOUND IS NOT NEW. HOWEVER,
RAPID IMPROVEMENTS OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND LARGE LANGUAGE
MODELS OR LLMS THAT ARE CAPABLE
OF GENERATING SOUND IMAGES AND
TEXT HAVE ALREADY RESULTED IN
THE CREATION OF MATERIALS THAT
ARE LIKELY TO PASS OFF AS
CONVINCINGLY REAL WHEN THEY ARE
INDEED FAKE. IN JANUARY OF THIS
YEAR, A ROBOCALL USING THE AI
GENERATED VOICE OF PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN TOLD NEW HAMPSHIRE VOTERS
TO, QUOTE, SAVE THEIR VOTE FOR
NOVEMBER RATHER THAN VOTE IN THE
STATE'S PRIMARY ELECTION. THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO CREATED THE AUDIO
TOLD NBC NEWS THAT, QUOTE, IT
TOOK LESS THAN 20 MINUTES AND IT
ONLY COST $1. AS THIS TECHNOLOGY
BECOMES CHEAPER, FASTER AND
EASIER FOR THE PUBLIC TO USE,
AND IT IS EMBRACED BY CANDIDATES
AND POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS, ITS
EFFECT ON DEMOCRACY REQUIRES US
TO ACT IN THIS NEW ENVIRONMENT.
SENSIBLE REGULATIONS THAT
PROTECT FREE POLITICAL
EXPRESSION AND SPEECH ARE VITAL
TO GET AHEAD OF THIS TECHNOLOGY.
RECENT AMENDMENTS LIMIT THIS
BILL TO THE ACTIVITIES OF STATE
CAMPAIGN COMMITTEES, AS DEFINED
BY THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT, AND
MOVE ENFORCEMENT RESPONSIBILITY
TO THE FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION. THIS CHANGE SENDS A
STRONG PRESIDENT OF MAKING
GENERATIVE AI DISCLOSURES A PART
OF OUR EXISTING TRANSPARENT
REQUIREMENTS HERE TO TALK MORE
OF THE NEED OF THE BILL IS TRACY
ROSENBERG WITH OAKLAND PRIVACY.
OH, HI AGAIN, HAPPY TO BE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2355, THIS BILL
COMES AS THE LEGISLATURE IS
FACING THE DEPLOYMENT OF A NEW
AND TRANSFORMATIONAL TECHNOLOGY.
AS YOU KNOW, AB 2355 SEEKS TO
HELP VOTERS TRYING TO
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN WHAT IS REAL
AND WHAT IS NOT AS THEY MAKE UP
THEIR MINDS HOW TO VOTE BY
REQUIRING THAT SYNTHETIC PAID
POLITICAL ADVERTISEMENTS THAT
ARE MATERIALLY, MATERIALLY
DECEPTIVE BE LABELED AS SUCH.
THIS PROVISION IS STRUCTURED IN
THE SAME MANNER AS OTHER LONG
STANDING CALIFORNIA LAWS THAT
REQUIRE LABELING AND DISCLOSURE
FOR PAID POLITICAL
ADVERTISEMENTS. IF THE LABELING
DOESN'T HAPPEN, THE FPPC CAN
TAKE ACTION. SO DECISIONS WITH
FIRST AMENDMENT RAMIFICATIONS
ARE MADE BY FOLKS WHO ARE
TRAINED IN INTERPRETING AND
APPLYING CONSTITUTIONAL LAWS. WE
THINK THAT IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT PART OF THE BILL. WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE FOCUS IN
TWO, THREE, FIVE, FIVE ON TRYING
TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM WITH
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF AND TAKING
ACTION, RATHER THAN JUST
RETROACTIVELY ASSESSING FINES,
PENALTIES AND FEES. AND WE HOPE
THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT AB 2355 AS
A RATIONAL AND MEASURED REACTION
TO THE PRESENCE OF AI CONTENT IN
OUR ELECTIONS. GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYBODY
ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT? THIS IS
NOW THE TIME FOR ME TO
TESTIMONY. GREAT THANK YOU,
NAOMI, ON BEHALF OF THE COMPUTER
AND COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU. LIZZIE
KUTSUNA HERE ON BEHALF OF
TECHNET IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYONE HERE IN THE
ROOM IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE, SEEING. NO. PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, CONCERNS.
BUELLER CAN I GET A MOTION?
ENJOYING WATCHING. OH, I HOPE
THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD. THAT'S
WHY I LOVE YOU SO MUCH. OKAY, WE
HAVE A MOTION. YOU MAY CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS BILL ITEM 54
AND THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
UMBERG WILK WILK. AYE. ALLEN
ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE.
CABALLERO DURAZZO. LAIRD LAIRD.
AYE. NILO. NILO AYE. ROTH. ROTH.
AYE. STERN WAHAB. YOU GOT 6 TO 0
WITH MEMBERS MISSING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO
ADD ON. I. CHAIR, CAN I MAKE A
OFF AGENDA REMARK? ABSOLUTELY.
WHEN, POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE, I SUPPOSE. WHEN I WAS
IN THE ASSEMBLY, JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TESTIFYING, IT WAS
COLD ENOUGH. THERE TO HANG MEAT,
AND I CAME BACK HERE AND IT'S
WARM ENOUGH HERE TO PERSPIRE
UNDER MY COAT AND I'M WONDERING,
IF ANYTHING, IF OTHERS AGREE
WITH ME, IF WE COULD MAYBE PUT
THE TEMPERATURE DOWN. A DEGREE
OR TWO. OTHERWISE YOU MIGHT
START HEARING ME SNORING.
ACTUALLY, ON BEHALF OF THE
CHAIR, BECAUSE WE HAD THIS ISSUE
LAST TIME WE WERE HERE, HE MADE
THE REQUEST. SO DGS IS AWARE OF
IT. AND THIS IS THE BEST THAT
THEY CAN DO. AND AGAIN, IT'S
GOVERNMENT WORK. SO YOU KNOW
IT'S THE BEST THEY CAN DO. ALL
RIGHT. WITH THAT WE HAVE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN BONTA AND WANT TO
YOU GOT A TRIFECTA TODAY. DO YOU
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND START WITH
FILE ITEM 57. IS THAT AB 3161.
IT ISN'T. BUT WE CAN START WITH
THAT ONE WOULD BE GREAT. THANK
YOU. OKAY SO WE'LL START A FILE
ITEM 59 AB 3161. AND WITH THAT
FLOOR IS YOURS. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I AUTHORIZE
THIS BILL BECAUSE BLACK,
INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCE HIGHER
RATES OF MEDICAL MISDIAGNOSES
AND PATIENT ADVERSE EVENTS WHEN
COMPARED TO WHITE PATIENTS. THIS
BILL REQUIRES HOSPITAL SAFETY
PLANS TO INCLUDE A PROCESS FOR
ADDRESSING RACISM AND
DISCRIMINATION AND ITS IMPACTS
ON PATIENT HEALTH AND SAFETY,
INCLUDING MONITORING
SOCIODEMOGRAPHIC DISPARITIES AND
PATIENT SAFETY EVENTS.
DEVELOPING INTERVENTIONS TO
REMEDY KNOWN DISPARITIES, AND
ENCOURAGING FACILITY STAFF TO
REPORT SUSPECTS, SUSPECTED
INSTANCES OF RACISM AND
DISCRIMINATION. THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES HOSPITALS TO REPORT
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH WHEN
REPORTING ADVERSE PATIENT
EVENTS, AND FOR D.P.H TO
FACILITATE THE INCLUSION OF
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA. WHEN SOMEONE
IS FILLING A FILING, A COMPLAINT
REGARDING A HEALTH FACILITY, WE
CAN'T SOLVE THE PROBLEMS OF
RACIAL BIAS AND DISPARITIES IN
PATIENT SAFETY EVENTS UNTIL WE
HAVE REAL DATA ABOUT THE SCOPE
OF THE PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA,
THIS BILL WILL HELP PROVIDE THAT
DATA VERY SIMPLY. WITH ME TODAY,
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT IS VANESSA
CAJINA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK AND ON BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS. THANK YOU. AND YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU,
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU.
WELL, MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE, MY NAME IS ONOMO
IKEA, AND I'M POLICY DIRECTOR
WITH BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS
ACTION PROJECT, WHERE
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE, COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO
IMPROVING THE HEALTH STATUS AND
WELL-BEING OF BLACK WOMEN AND
GIRLS. I'M HERE AS A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB 3161, THE EQUITY
IN HEALTH CARE ACT, WHICH WILL
WORK TO ADDRESS THE RACIAL AND
IMPLICIT BIAS IN HEALTH CARE AND
SUPPORT ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO EXPERIENCE
HARM DUE TO DISCRIMINATION WHEN
RECEIVING CARE. ADVERSE HEALTH
EVENTS TAKE MANY FORMS, AND
RESEARCH REVEALS THAT
DISPARITIES IN QUALITY OF CARE
EXIST ACROSS A VARIETY OF THE
PATIENT SAFETY INDICATORS. WITH
BLACK, INDIGENOUS, AND OTHER
PEOPLE OF COLOR BEARING THE
BURDEN. EVEN AS QUALITY OF CARE
AND OUTCOMES HAVE IMPROVED FOR
EVERYONE, RACIAL AND, RACIAL AND
ETHNIC DISPARITIES PERSIST IN
THE US AND CALIFORNIA. THE
DISPROPORTIONATELY POOR HEALTH
OUTCOMES IN MATERNAL MORBIDITY
AND MORTALITY THAT BURDEN BLACK
MAMAS AND BIRTHING PEOPLE IS
EMBLEMATIC OF THIS. WE KNOW THE
STATISTICS MORE THAN 80% OF
PREGNANCY RELATED DEATHS HAVE
BEEN FOUND BY MATERNAL MORTALITY
REVIEW COMMITTEES TO BE
PREVENTABLE. BLACK MAMAS ARE
MORE THAN THREE TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO DIE FROM PREGNANCY
RELATED CAUSES, REGARDLESS OF
TYPICALLY MITIGATING FACTORS OF
EDUCATION AND SOCIOECONOMIC
STATUS, BLACK MAMAS AND BIRTHING
PEOPLE ARE OFFERED FEWER
TREATMENT OPTIONS. FREQUENCY
FREQUENTLY EXPERIENCED DELAYS IN
CARE, AND ARE SUBJECTED TO BIAS
DECISION MAKING. WE KNOW THE
DEVASTATING AND HARROWING
STORIES, WHETHER IT'S OF APRIL
VALENTINE, BRIDGET KROMER OR MY
DEAR FRIEND WHOSE MULTIPLE
COMPLAINTS THAT ABOUT
UNCHARACTERISTIC HEADACHES
DURING HER PREGNANCY WENT
IGNORED BY HER DOCTOR, LEADING
TO AN EMERGENCY C-SECTION TO
DELIVER HER BABY AT 1 POUND.
LUCKILY, THEY BOTH SURVIVED THE
ORDEAL, BUT NOT WITHOUT LASTING
EFFECTS. OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
BURDENED WITH SUCH STORIES OF
DEATH, NEAR DEATH AND SEVERE
MORBIDITY AND INJURY. WHAT
HAPPENS AFTERWARDS? WHAT
PROTOCOLS ARE IN PLACE TO
ADDRESS ADVERSE HEALTH SAFETY
EVENTS THAT LIKELY RESULTED FROM
DISCRIMINATION OR RACISM? WHAT
IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO WORK TO
ENSURE THAT THESE ADVERSE EVENTS
DO NOT OCCUR? AGAIN, THIS BILL
SAYS THINK ABOUT
SOCIODEMOGRAPHIC FACTORS IN THE
ANALYSIS OF ADVERSE EVENTS. IT
SAYS, AT LEAST CREATE A SAFETY
PLAN AND PROTOCOLS REFLECTIVE OF
AND RESPONSIVE TO THE CRISIS AT
HAND, IT SAYS. AT MINIMUM,
REPORT AND TRACK THE DATA. THAT
GIVES US A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
AND CLEARER PICTURE OF THE
ISSUES OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE. THE
STORIES SCARS, VISIBLE AND
INVISIBLE AND INEQUITABLE HEALTH
OUTCOMES. TO DEMONSTRATE THAT
BIAS, RACIAL, GENDER AND A SLEW
OF OTHERS EXIST IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. SORRY, I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE WELL OVER OKAY, I
APOLOGIZE, I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON THIS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BILL. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION. AND
THANK YOU, CHAIR BONTA, FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. I
APPRECIATE YOUR PASSION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. VANESSA CAJINA WITH KP
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK. THE PROUD CO-SPONSORS
OF AB 3161. TO PUT IT VERY
SIMPLY, IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
DATA, WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT
IT. THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA ON THIS BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU, ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE.
MILLIKEN. GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR MEMBERS SANDRA
POOLE FROM WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HELLO. MY NAME IS KIM
ROBINSON. I'M WITH BLACK WOMEN
FOR WELLNESS AND BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS ACTION PROJECT AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
HELLO, I AM NAYELI ASTORGA. I
ATTEND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, IRVINE AND I AM IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI, MY NAME
IS CECILIA ANAYA AND I ATTENDED
A STEINORTH STATE UNIVERSITY.
I'M FROM STOCKTON AND I'M IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CAROL GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF HOPE HISPANIC
ORGANIZED FOR POLITICAL EQUALITY
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
JENNIFER ROBLES WITH HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LANDLADY FROM ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM IN OPPOSITION SEEING NONE
PULL IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
COME ON PEOPLE OKAY. YOU WANT TO
TALK? QUESTION. JUST A MOTION TO
, THERE WAS A YOU GUYS REACHED
AN ACCORD WITH THE WITH THE
COMMITTEE. YOU ACCEPT THE. I
THINK THAT'S A DIFFERENT BILL.
OKAY. I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY, I'M
SORRY, I'M SORRY. BUT THE ANSWER
TO THAT WE TOOK WE TOOK IT OUT
OF ORDER. BUT THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION IS YES. OKAY, OKAY. I
REALLY APOLOGIZE. I'M. I'M DEEP
IN ANOTHER RABBIT HOLE. THANK
YOU. BUT I'LL MOVE YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. I KNOW, I
KNOW YOUR OTHER BILL. I KNOW
SENATOR ALLEN. YEAH, NO OTHER
COMMENTS. I'LL JUST MAKE I'LL
JUST MAKE IT QUICK. WHEN I
TALKED EARLIER TODAY, IN THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY PORTION OF MY
DISTRICT, WHICH IS IN, IN, IN LA
COUNTY IS SERVICE PROVIDER AREA
ONE. IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA, IT
IT'S HORRIBLE. AND PARTICULARLY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT, WHEN IT
APPLIES TO BLACK WOMEN, INFANT
MORTALITY RATE. WHAT WHAT HAVE
YOU. IT'S LIKE THIRD WORLD
FIGURES. IT'S EMBARRASSING. SO
THERE'S PROBABLY MULTIPLE
REASONS FOR THAT. BUT CERTAINLY
WE SHOULD BE COLLECTING THE DATA
ON THIS TO SEE HOW MUCH OF THESE
ISSUES PLAY INTO THAT. SO I
THINK IT'S A GREAT BILL PLAN TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY. AND WITH THAT
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, I THINK YOU SAID IT
BEST. WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE DATA TO
SUPPORT. I WANT TO THANK THE OUR
TESTIMONIAL WITNESSES HERE WHO
ARE EXPERT IN THEIR FIELDS AND
WHO HAVE ENSURED THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
BILL. WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
THANK YOU. WITH THAT. OKAY. THIS
IS BILL ITEM 59 AB 3161. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED. THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. BERG
WILK. HI WILK. AYE. ALLEN.
ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE.
CABALLERO BARRASSO. LAIRD LAIRD.
AYE. NILO. NILO AYE. ROTH. ROTH.
AYE. STERN WAHAB. YOU HAVE 6 TO
0 WITH MEMBERS MISSING 6 TO 0.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OUR
COLLEAGUES TO ADD ON. DO YOU
WANT TO DO SENATOR ALLEN'S BILL
NEXT OR DO YOU WANT TO DO NEXT?
WE ARE GOING TO DO AB 846.
PERFECT. SO THAT'S FILE ITEM 57.
YES AND THE WE'RE REALLY
BOUNCING AROUND. WELL ARE YOU
TRYING TO CONFUSE US. NO. WE'RE
TRYING TO KEEP YOU GUYS AWAKE.
IT'S A LITTLE HOT IN HERE.
WHAT'S THE RECOMMENDATION? OKAY.
THIS HAS THE RECOMMENDATION. DO
PASS TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
SO WHEN YOU'RE READY, PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE TIME
SPENT ON THIS BILL. I DECIDED TO
AUTHOR AB 846 TO PROTECT LOW
INCOME RENTERS LIVING IN
PUBLICLY ASSISTED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FROM SIGNIFICANT RENT
SPIKES. THE LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM, OR LIHTC, IS
A CRITICAL SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION
AND REHABILITATION NATIONWIDE.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE WAY THAT
FEDERAL LAW REGULATES RENTS FOR
LIHTC UNITS PROVIDES NO
ASSURANCES THAT A TENANT'S RENT
WILL REMAIN AFFORDABLE OVER
TIME. TENANTS HAVE TO INCOME
QUALIFY FOR LIHTC UNITS AND WILL
PAY ANYWHERE BETWEEN 30% AND 40%
OF THEIR INCOME IN RENT AT THE
START OF THEIR TENANCY IN LIHTC
PROPERTIES, THERE IS NO
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN A TENANT'S
INCOME AND THEIR RENT. OVER
TIME, RENT INCREASES ARE SOLELY
TIED TO INCREASES IN AMI FOR THE
COUNTY IN WHICH THE PROPERTY IS
LOCATED. LIHTC PROPERTY OWNERS
ARE FREE TO RAISE RENTS UP TO
THE NEW ALLOWABLE MAXIMUM
WHENEVER AMI RISES. THIS MEANS
THAT LIHTC TENANTS CAN FACE
UNPREDICTABLE AND OFTEN HIGH
RENT INCREASES. OVER TIME. THEY
CAN BECOME SEVERELY RENT
BURDENED, PAYING OVER 50% OF
THEIR INCOME IN RENT DESPITE
LIVING IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING,
THEY ARE NOT LIVING IN HOUSING
THAT THEY CAN AFFORD. THERE IS A
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM. STATES
CAN IMPOSE ADDITIONAL
RESTRICTIONS ON RENTS IN LIHTC
PROPERTIES, AND A GROWING NUMBER
OF STATES HAVE DONE JUST THAT.
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THIS
AUTHORITY, THE TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE, OR TCAC,
WHICH OVERSEES THE LATECH
PROGRAM, RECENTLY ADOPTED A SET
OF REGULATIONS THAT APPLY A RENT
CATALYTIC PROPERTIES AS A
CONDITION OF GETTING NEW TAX
CREDITS. THESE REGULATIONS ALLOW
FOR A WAIVER FROM THE CAP TO
ENSURE THE FINANCIAL VIABILITY
OF A PROPERTY, AND ALSO INCLUDE
A NUMBER OF OTHER PROVISIONS
THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS HAVE RAISED AS A
CRITIC. AS CRITICAL DURING OUR
NEGOTIATIONS OVER THIS BILL OVER
THE LAST 18 MONTHS, INCLUDING
THE ABILITY TO EXCEED THE CAP IN
ORDER TO BRING A TENANT UP TO
THE PAYING 30% OF THEIR INCOME
IN RENT. UNFORTUNATELY TCAC DID
NOT BELIEVE IT HAD CLEAR LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO APPLY THE NEW CAP
TO EXISTING PROPERTIES. THIS
LEAVES TENANTS IN THE EXISTING
PROPERTIES INCREDIBLY VULNERABLE
TO HIGH RENT INCREASES. WE WANT
TO AVOID. AB 846 PROVIDES THE
NECESSITY, THE NECESSARY CLARITY
BY DIRECTING TCAC TO ESTABLISH A
LIMIT ON RENT INCREASES IN
EXISTING LIHTC PROPERTIES IN
CALIFORNIA. I UNDERSTAND AND
RESPECT THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED BY NONPROFIT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS IN
PARTICULAR ABOUT THE NEED FOR
SOME FLEXIBILITY AND TO
CAREFULLY CONSIDER HOW A CAP
WOULD WORK WITHIN THE ALREADY
COMPLEX REGULATIONS THAT GOVERN
LIGHT TECH PROPERTIES. THIS BILL
DOES JUST THAT BY ASKING TCAC TO
APPLY ITS CAREFULLY CRAFTED NEW
RENT CAP REGULATIONS TO ALL
EXISTING LIGHT TECH PROPERTIES.
IT PROTECTS TENANTS AND GIVES
DEVELOPERS THE FLEXIBILITY THEY
NEED. WITH ME TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THIS BILL IS ANNIE LAWLER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND KAREN
KATZ FROM LEGAL SERVICES OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. I THINK I
DIDN'T SAY THAT YOUR LAST NAME.
RIGHT. NO. THAT'S OKAY. WELCOME
BACK. YOU GET TWO MINUTES. HELLO
AGAIN. I'M KAREN KARNES,
REGIONAL COUNSEL FOR HOUSING AT
LEGAL SERVICES OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN OUR 23
COUNTY SERVICE AREA IS FUNDED,
AT LEAST IN PART, THROUGH THE LÀ
TECH PROGRAM IN OROVILLE. THERE
ARE TWO NEW LOW TECH PROPERTIES
WHICH CAME INTO SERVICE LAST
YEAR ONE SERVE SENIORS AND ONE
SERVES FAMILIES. LIZ CHICO
OFFICE HAS REPRESENTED SEVERAL
CLIENTS AT THE PROPERTY FOR LOW
INCOME SENIORS WHO RECEIVED
MULTIPLE RENT INCREASES IN A
YEAR AT THIS SENIOR PROPERTY,
OUR CLIENTS MOVED INTO THEIR
BRAND NEW AFFORDABLE UNITS IN
THE FALL OF 2023. THE RENT FOR A
ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT AT 60% OF
THE AMI WAS $808. THEIR RENT
WENT UP TO 847. IN MARCH 2024,
AND THE TENANTS FACE ANOTHER
INCREASE TO 950 IN SEPTEMBER.
THIS IS AN 18% INCREASE IN LESS
THAN A YEAR. THE FOLKS WHO LIVE
AT THIS PROPERTY, LIKE ALL
SENIOR LIVE TECH BUILDINGS, ARE
PRIMARILY ON FIXED INCOMES.
THEIR INCOMES DO NOT INCREASE
WHEN THE AMI COME OUT EVERY
YEAR, THEY ONLY BECOME MORE RENT
BURDENED AT ANOTHER COMPLEX. FOR
FAMILIES RUN BY THE SAME COMPANY
IN OROVILLE, RENTS HAVE BEEN
INCREASED BY 20% IN ONE YEAR
THROUGH MULTIPLE RENT INCREASES.
THESE MID LEASE RENT INCREASES
ARE CURRENTLY ALLOWED BY
FREDERICK. FEDERAL REGULATIONS,
BUT THOSE SAME REGULATIONS ALSO
GIVE STATES THE AUTHORITY TO
LIMIT THEM. AS A NUMBER OF
STATES HAVE DONE, THE SENIORS
AND FAMILIES WHO JUST MOVED INTO
THESE NEW LOW TECH PROPERTIES
ARE ILLUSTRATIVE OF THE
EXPERIENCE OF THOUSANDS OF LOW
TECH TENANTS ACROSS THE STATE,
MANY OF THEM SENIORS AND FOLKS
ON FIXED INCOMES WHO MAKE IT OFF
YEARS LONG WAIT LISTS. FINALLY,
GET INTO TECH HOUSING THAT
THEY'RE TOLD WILL BE AFFORDABLE,
ONLY TO FIND THE RENT QUICKLY
BECOMES AFFORDABLE AND THE
HOUSING UNTENABLE. AND FOR THESE
REASONS, LIZ SUPPORTS REQUIRING
TCAC TO LIMIT RENT GOUGING
GOUGING ON EXISTING PROPERTIES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS. ANNIE LAWLER HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION. IN THE 18 MONTHS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS BILL,
WE'VE GATHERED HUNDREDS OF
TENANT STORIES SIMILAR TO THE
ONES KAREN JUST SPOKE ABOUT.
THIS IS A PUBLICLY FUNDED
PROGRAM DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY TO
PRODUCE HOUSING AFFORDABLE TO
LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. IT'S
HARD TO SEE HOW THESE STORIES
ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE
PROGRAM'S INTENT. WHEN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GROUPS ASKED
TO BE EXEMPTED FROM THE STATE'S
TENANT PROTECTION ACT IN 2019,
THE ARGUMENT WAS THAT RENT
GOUGING WASN'T AN ISSUE IN THESE
PROPERTIES BECAUSE THE
REGULATIONS OF PROGRAMS SUCH AS
LIGHT TECH ALREADY PREVENT
EXCESSIVE RENT INCREASES.
CLEARLY THIS IS NOT THE CASE. I
WANT TO SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS
CONCERNS. WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
APPLYING A RENT CAP TO EXISTING
LIGHT TECH PROPERTIES. THE
AVERAGE TCAC PROJECT IS
UNDERWRITTEN WITH THE ASSUMPTION
OF 2.5% TO 3.5% ANNUAL RENT
GROWTH, ASSUMING TCAC COMPLIES
WITH THIS BILL BY APPLYING ITS
EXISTING CAP ON PROSPECTIVE
PROPERTIES, WHICH IS 5% PLUS CPI
OR NO MORE THAN 10% IDENTICAL TO
THE CAP THAT APPLIES TO MARKET
RATE APARTMENTS UNDER THE TENANT
PROTECTION ACT. SUCH A CAP WOULD
NOT IMPACT A PROJECT'S OVERALL
FINANCING ASSUMPTIONS OVER TIME.
IN ADDITION, AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HAS SAID, FEDERAL LAW
EXPRESSLY ALLOWS STATES TO
REGULATE LIGHT TECH RENT
INCREASES TO FURTHER STATE
HOUSING GOALS. AND I WOULD
ASSUME THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR LOW INCOME.
SPECTRAL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON. CAITLIN
JOHNSON WITH POLITICAL SOLUTIONS
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THANK
YOU. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE. LET'S
BRING IT BACK. COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SEEING NO QUESTIONS. OR IS THERE
A MOTION? IS THERE A MOTION?
SENATOR ASHBY MOVES THE BILL ALL
RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU. MEMBERS, I SHARED THE
STORY. WITH THE PERMISSION OF MY
MOTHER. SHE MOVED INTO A HOUSING
APARTMENT IN RICHMOND,
CALIFORNIA. WHEN SHE RETIRED
BECAUSE SHE WANTED TO BE CLOSER
TO HER GRANDCHILDREN. SHE WHEN
SHE STARTED LIVING THERE, SHE
WAS ON, SHE WAS WORKING A PART
TIME JOB IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
RETIRE. AND SHE WAS AT THE TIME
AT 30% OF RENT, IN TERMS OF HER
TOTAL BURDEN FROM HER INCOME, BY
THE TIME SHE LEFT THERE, HAD
BEEN A 20% INCREASE IN THE
AMOUNT OF RENT THAT SHE PAID, AT
WHICH POINT SHE HAD TO TURN TO
ME AND SAY, I DON'T THINK I CAN
AFFORD TO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA
ANYMORE. THIS BILL IS VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD. IT ESSENTIALLY
ALLOWS US TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
LIHTC PROPERTIES, CONTINUE TO BE
AFFORDABLE, NOT ONLY FOR THE
PROSPECTIVE PROPERTIES THAT WILL
COME, BUT ALSO THE ONES THAT ARE
ALREADY IN EXISTENCE. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR VOTE. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
CHIEF COUNSEL, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FILE. ITEM 57 AB 846. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. UMBERG
A UMBERG I WILK NØ WILK NÓ.
ALLEN. ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I
CABALLERO. DURAZO. LAIRD LAIRD I
NILO NO. NILO NO. ROTH HERE.
STERN. WAHAB, YOU HAVE
FORWARDED, FORWARDED TO WITH
MEMBERS MISSING, ROTH. ROTH. I
THAT'S 5 TO 2 WITH MEMBERS
MISSING. ALRIGHTY, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT BILL IS FILE
NUMBER 58, AB 2239, THIS IS A
QUICK ONE. SO IT COULD BE RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, SOME MEMBER. BONTA,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. FIRST, I WANT TO START
BY SAYING I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT. I WANT TO NOTE THAT
DUE TO TIME CONSTRAINTS,
LANGUAGE ADOPTED IN ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS,
WHICH SOME OF YOU JUST SAW
MOMENTS AGO AROUND WHO IS
COVERED UNDER THE DEFINITION OF
COVERED ENTITIES IN THIS BILL,
IS MISSING KEY GUARDRAILS THAT I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
BOTH THIS COMMITTEE STAFF AND
OTHERS TO ADD THAT BILL LANGUAGE
AT A LATER DATE, SHOULD IT BE
MOVED FORWARD. AB 2239 ADDRESSES
A CRITICAL ISSUE IN OUR DIGITAL
AGE, ENSURING EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO BROADBAND INTERNET SERVICES
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. AS YOU
WILL HEAR FROM MY WITNESSES,
CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE IN AREAS
WITH PREDOMINANTLY LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
DISCONNECTED IN LIGHT OF THE
INCREASING RELIANCE ON DIGITAL
TECHNOLOGIES FOR EDUCATION,
WORK, HEALTH CARE AND
COMMUNICATION, IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT WE PREVENT DIGITAL
DISCRIMINATION AND PROMOTE
FAIRNESS AND ACCESS TO SUCH AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. FIRST AB 2239 ADOPTS
THE FCC DEFINITION OF DIGITAL
DISCRIMINATION, WHICH
ESTABLISHES A CLEAR DEFINITION
FOR DIGITAL DISCRIMINATION OF
ACCESS. THIS DEFINITION PROVIDES
A FRAMEWORK FOR IDENTIFYING AND
ADDRESSING DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES IN BROADBAND INTERNET
PROVISION. IN ADDITION, AB 2239
EXPRESSLY PROHIBITS INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND WITH THE
AMENDMENTS ALSO PROHIBIT COVERED
ENTITIES FROM ENGAGING IN
DIGITAL DISCRIMINATION OF
ACCESS, WHICH IS DEFINED AS
POLICIES OR PRACTICES THAT
DISPARATELY OR DIFFERENTIALLY
IMPACT CONSUMERS ACCESS BASED ON
FACTORS SUCH AS RACE, ETHNICITY,
RELIGION, OR NATIONAL ORIGIN.
MEMBERS. WE DO NOT KNOW WHAT THE
FUTURE OF BROADBAND WILL BE, BUT
WHAT THE FUTURE OF BROADBAND
SHOULDN'T BE IS DISCRIMINATORY.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ARE
PAUL GOODMAN, LEGAL COUNSEL AT
THE CENTER FOR ACCESSIBLE
TECHNOLOGY, AND PATRICK MESICK,
DIRECTOR OF OAKLAND UNDIVIDED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA, CHAIR
UMBERG, VICE CHAIR, WILK AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M
PATRICK MESICK, DIRECTOR OF
OAKLAND UNDIVIDED. WE ARE
CO-SPONSORS OF AB 2239, ALONG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
DIGITAL EQUITY, CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION, NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA, AND THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP. I'M SPEAKING TODAY
FOR ALL OF US AND THE MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS OUR COALITION
COLLECTIVELY SERVES AS. MY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARED THE FACTS
OF THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE STARK. RACE AND
INCOME ARE THE BEST PREDICTORS
OF WHETHER YOU'RE STUCK ON THE
WRONG SIDE OF THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
PREDOMINANTLY LOW INCOME AND
THOSE THAT ARE PREDOMINANTLY
NONWHITE CONSISTENTLY,
SYSTEMATICALLY HAVE FEWER
OPTIONS, RECEIVE WORSE SERVICE,
AND PAY MORE FOR THAT SERVICE.
IN OAKLAND, WE TESTED MORE THAN
15,000 LOCATIONS AND DOCUMENTED
THAT THE CONNECTIONS IN THE
HIGHEST INCOME, WIDEST ZIP CODE
WERE, ON AVERAGE TEN TIMES
FASTER THAN IN OUR POOREST
COMMUNITY, WITH THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE OF COLOR.
DESPITE RESIDENTS SUBSCRIBING TO
AND PAYING FOR SIMILAR TIERS OF
SERVICE PATTERNS, MIRRORING
REDLINING FROM THE 1930S, OUR
PARTNERS AT THE FRESNO COALITION
FOR DIGITAL INCLUSION HAVE
DOCUMENTED 15 MILLION DATA
POINTS COLLECTED FROM TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF LOCATIONS OVER THAT
TIME, DOCUMENTING THE SAME
PATTERN. YOU MIGHT ASSUME THAT
THESE WEALTHY COMMUNITIES HAVE
HIGHER QUALITY CONNECTIONS
BECAUSE THEY PAY MORE FOR
INTERNET, BUT THE OPPOSITE IS
TRUE POOR COMMUNITIES PAY MORE
FOR WORST INTERNET IN LÀ, THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
HAS DOCUMENTED IN LÀ, THE
HAS DOCUMENTED THAT THE
ADVERTISED COST OF INTERNET
SERVICE IS SYSTEMATICALLY HIGHER
IN NEIGHBORHOODS WITH HIGHER
POVERTY RATES. INDEPENDENT
RESEARCHERS HAVE VERIFIED THESE
FINDINGS AT SCALE. A TEAM AT UC
SANTA BARBARA STUDY MORE THAN
35,000 RESIDENTIAL ADDRESSES IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND
CONCLUDED THAT, QUOTE, WEALTHIER
AREAS RECEIVE MORE BANDWIDTH FOR
LESS MONEY. WE CANNOT CLAIM TO
CARE ABOUT BROADBAND FOR ALL,
WHILE IGNORING THE STARK REALITY
OF THE DISPARATE IMPACT OF THE
POLICIES AND PRACTICES THAT HAVE
DELIVERED AN ENDURING,
PERSISTENT DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
CONTINUE TO EXACERBATE IT. ON
BEHALF OF THE BILL'S SPONSORS
AND THE EXTENSIVE LIST OF
SUPPORTERS, I URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO SEE PAST THE
SMOKESCREENS THE CONFUSING
HYPOTHETICALS AND THE SCARE
MONGERING I'VE KNOWN TO BE SEEN
IN THIS DISCUSSION OF THE BILL.
ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. GEORGE AND I VOTE YES
. RIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME
IS PAUL GOODMAN. I'M A LEGAL
COUNSEL WITH THE CENTER FOR
ACCESSIBLE TECHNOLOGY, AND FOR
THE LAST 15 YEARS, THE FOCUS OF
MY WORK HAS BEEN THE
INTERSECTION BETWEEN
TELECOMMUNICATIONS POLICY
DISCRIMINATION AND HISTORICAL
DISCRIMINATION AND ANTITRUST. MY
PRESENTATION AND I APOLOGIZE, IS
GOING TO BE A LITTLE BIT DRIER.
BUT DURING THIS WHOLE DISCUSSION
OF THIS BILL, ONE THING IS VERY
CLEAR THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
DISPARATE IMPACTS ON COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR WHEN IT COMES TO
BROADBAND ACCESS, WHAT THERE, I
THINK SEEMS TO BE A LACK OF
CLARITY ABOUT, IS WHAT IT
ACTUALLY TAKES TO PROVE A
DISPARATE IMPACT. AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ASKING THIS
QUESTION EARLIER TODAY, THE FCC
ORDER ACTUALLY DOES AN EXCELLENT
JOB OF TALKING ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT BURDENS OF PROOF FOR
DIFFERENT KINDS OF BEHAVIOR. THE
FIRST TWO ARE FOR SHOWING
INTENTIONAL BEHAVIOR, WHICH I
DON'T THINK IS AN ISSUE HERE.
THE DISPARATE IMPACT WILL
BASICALLY SAYS, YOU HAVE TO
PROVE THAT A POLICY OR PRACTICE
CAUSES A DISPARATE IMPACT. I
WILL COME BACK TO THAT IN A
MOMENT. IF THAT HAPPENS, THEN A
PROVIDER OR THE PERSON BEING
ACCUSED OF ENGAGING IN
DISCRIMINATION, HAS A CHANCE TO
SHOW THAT THERE WAS A TECHNICAL
OR ECONOMIC REASON THAT MADE
THIS INFEASIBLE, ALSO THAT THERE
WAS NO REASONABLY ACHIEVABLE,
LESS DISCRIMINATING ALTERNATIVE.
I'LL POINT OUT THAT THAT SECOND
ISSUE, TECHNICAL ECONOMIC
FEASIBILITY, THERE'S ACTUALLY A
BROADER LATITUDE FOR PROVIDERS
IN THIS BILL BECAUSE IT INCLUDES
LEGITIMATE TECHNICAL OR ECONOMIC
, JUSTIFICATION. BUT LET ME TALK
ABOUT THE BURDEN OF PROOF TO
SHOW THAT THERE'S BEEN A
DISPARATE IMPACT. YOU HAVE TO
SHOW THAT THERE'S A PROTECTED
CLASS. THEN YOU HAVE TO COMPARE
THOSE THAT PROTECTED CLASS TO
OTHER SIMILARLY SITUATED, SAY,
CONSUMERS. AND THAT SAMPLE HAS
TO BE REPRESENTATIVE. SO YOU
HAVE TO SHOW THAT YOUR SAMPLE IS
REPRESENTATIVE, AND THEN THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT WAYS
TO DETERMINE HOW SIGNIFICANT
THAT IMPACT IS, THE SORT OF MOST
STRAIGHTFORWARD ONE IS DOING
SOME STATISTICAL ANALYSIS. AND
IF IT'S 2 OR 3 STANDARD
DEVIATIONS AWAY FROM, THE NORM,
THAT'S A FLAG THAT THERE'S A
PROBLEM, THERE'S ALSO WHAT WE
CALLED THE 4/5 RULE WHERE, SAY,
IF YOU CAN SHOW THAT BLACK
APPLICANTS FOR A JOB, TAKE A JOB
EXAM AND THEY'RE PASSING THAT
EXAM AT 80, THE RATE OF WHITE
APPLICANTS, THAT'S AN INDICATION
THAT THE IT'S A SIGNIFICANT AND
ALSO WHICH I THINK IS A REALLY
CLEVER FACTOR, IS THAT THERE'S
YOU LOOK AT THE DIFFERENCE IN
THE MAGNITUDE OF IMPACTS. SO IF
I'M IN A NEIGHBOR RIGHT,
PREDOMINANTLY WHITE NEIGHBORHOOD
AND I'M GETTING TWO GIGABIT
SPEEDS AND THE NEIGHBORHOOD NEXT
TO ME IS PREDOMINANTLY BLACK AND
GETS ONE GIGABIT SPEEDS, THAT'S
QUITE A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN QUITE
A BIT DIFFERENT THAN TWO
GIGABITS AND SAY, DIGITAL
SUBSCRIBER LINE SERVICE, WHICH
WOULD BE MUCH MORE EXTREME. AND
THEN FINALLY YOU HAVE TO SHOW
CAUSATION. SO IT'S NOT ENOUGH
THAT YOU JUST SAY DISPARATE
IMPACT I'M GUESSING YOU URGE AND
I VOTE ALSO. ABSOLUTELY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GIVE US YOUR NAME,
YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION. AND IF YOU'RE STANDING
IN THE HALLWAY, NOW WOULD BE A
GOOD TIME. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN THIS BILL TO COME
INTO THE COME INTO THE ROOM,
WHETHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION, GO AHEAD. NICOLE
WATERMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP
CO-SPONSOR, FRESNO COALITION FOR
DIGITAL INCLUSION AND UNITE LÀ
AND SUPPORT MONNING, THANK YOU.
ON BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MURATSUCHI GONZALEZ,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR DIGITAL EQUITY AND
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA, TWO
CO-SPONSORS OF THE BILL IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
HELLO. MY NAME IS SHIRLEY LAM
WITH INSURED THE UNINSURED
PROJECT AND SUPPORTED THIS BILL
ALSO EXPRESSING SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY CLINIC
ASSOCIATION OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. EVERYONE ON HACK THE
HOOD, OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT, TECH REPAIR PROGRAM,
OAKLAND NATIONAL ASSOCIATION FOR
THE ADVANCEMENT OF COLORED
PEOPLE, OAKLAND YOUTH
COMMISSION, AND THE TECH
EXCHANGE. THANK YOU. BELLA KERN,
ON BEHALF OF MICHELSON CENTER
FOR PUBLIC POLICY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. STELLA JOHNSON, ON
BEHALF OF SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT, IN SUPPORT OF
THIS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION,
CO-SPONSOR IN SUPPORT. AND I
HAVE 15 OTHERS, GREAT PUBLIC
SCHOOLS NOW, ALLIANCE FOR A
BETTER COMMUNITY. COMMUNITY
COALITION OF THE ANTELOPE VALLEY
DESTINATION CRENSHAW ARTS FOR LA
COMMUNITIES, AND SCHOOLS OF LOS
ANGELES, HEALING AND JUSTICE
CENTER, INNOVATIVE OR INNOVATE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS, FAMILIES AND
SCHOOLS. LATINO EQUALITY
ALLIANCE, OUR VOICE COMMUNITIES
FOR QUALITY EDUCATION. PARA LOS
NINOS, SOUTHEAST COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION, UNITED
PARENTS AND STUDENTS, AND THE
ANGELENO PROJECT IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. BETH MALINOWSKI WITH
SEIU CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT, ANDY
CHAO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT,
TRACY ROSENBERG ON BEHALF OF
MEDIA ALLIANCE, IN SUPPORT. ANDY
BIRNBAUM, ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. CYNTHIA
GOMEZ, DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF STATE
POLICY AND ADVOCACY WITH THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS, CHIRLA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS B¢O DIANA. I
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SASHA
HOROWITZ, LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WITH CHIRLA, I
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI, DOCTOR.
ADRIAN TINNIN I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF RACE EQUITY POLICY AT THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK, AND WE
HAVE AN IN-BETWEEN POSITION. WE
ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
PRINCIPLES OF THIS BILL, BUT WE
ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
CALIFORNIA PASSING LAW THAT IS
WEAKER THAN FEDERAL LAW. WE URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO RESTORE. ARE
YOU IN SUPPORT? ARE YOU IN
SUPPORT? SORRY. ARE YOU IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION? JUST
GIVING AN IN BETWEEN POSITION
RIGHT HERE. OUR OFFICIAL LETTER
IS OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED. ALL
RIGHT. WELL GO AHEAD AND SEND
THE LETTER. THANK YOU SO MUCH
OKAY OKAY. THANK YOU, ALL RIGHT,
LET'S NOW TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
, AB 2239, PLEASE APPROACH. I'M.
BEFORE WE TAKE OPPOSITION, I
HAVE TO APOLOGIZE BECAUSE
APPARENTLY THEY'RE HOLDING THE
ROLL OPEN IN HOUSING FOR ME. SO
I WANTED TO ASK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SPENDING AS MUCH QUALITY TIME AS
YOU HAVE WITH ME ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE. INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE, AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR DEDICATED
DEDICATION. DETERMINATION, ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAD
DISCUSSED IS THE ENFORCEMENT.
ONE OF THE THINGS I WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT WAS THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE BILL. I HAVE
NOT ISSUED A RECOMMENDATION YET,
BUT I WOULD ASK YOU IF WE COULD
LIMIT ENFORCEMENT TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, IF WE COULD
ATTORNEY GENERAL. IF YOU'RE
AMENABLE TO THAT AMENDMENT, THEN
I'M PREPARED TO BOTH VOTE AYE
AND MAKE A RECOMMENDATION TO THE
COMMITTEE. SUPPORT THE BILL. SO
I'M INTERESTED IN YOUR RESPONSE
BEFORE I LEAVE. THANK YOU,
CHAIR, AND THANK YOU FOR,
ENGAGING IN CONVERSATION WITH ME
LATE INTO THE NIGHT ON THIS. I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
DEDICATION. I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION AND AM WILLING TO
ACCEPT THAT, AMENDMENT OR A
LEVEL OF ENFORCEMENT LIMITED TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IF YOU
THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE. ALL
RIGHT, WELL, I DO SO. OKAY.
WELL, THEN THEN I ACCEPT YOUR
COMMITMENT. AND THE NEXT
COMMITTEE, I BELIEVE, IS GOING
TO APPROPRIATIONS AFTER THIS
LEAVES THIS COMMITTEE, SHOULD IT
LEAVE THE COMMITTEE THEN? THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND
I'LL BE BACK, SENATOR WILK,
THANK YOU. THIS IS LIKE DEJA VU.
ALL OVER AGAIN. DID I SEE YOU
GUYS THIS MORNING? ANYWAY YOU
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES, AND
PLEASE START. THANK YOU, AMANDA
GUADERRAMA WITH CAL BROADBAND.
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE GOAL OF
AB 2239, WE DISAGREE WITH THE
METHOD AND MUST OPPOSE THE BILL.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
FCC RULED TO WHICH THIS BILL IS
MODELED AFTER IS UNDER
LITIGATION WITHIN THE FEDERAL
COURT. CURRENTLY, WITH OPENING
ARGUMENTS BEGINNING IN
SEPTEMBER. THE DISAGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE DIFFERENCE IN
LIABILITY STANDARDS IS PART OF
THIS LITIGATION, SO UTILIZING
THE STANDARD IN STATE STATUTE IS
PREMATURE AND IS RIPE FOR ITS
OWN LITIGATION CHALLENGE.
SIMILAR TO THE FCC'S, THE
DISPARATE IMPACT STANDARD DOES
NOT REQUIRE ANY INTENT TO
DISCRIMINATE. FOR EXAMPLE,
PLAINTIFFS COULD ALLEGE THAT
FAILURE TO UPGRADE OR DEPLOY NEW
TECHNOLOGIES IN ALL COMMUNITIES
SIMULTANEOUSLY HAS A DISPARATE
IMPACT, BECAUSE THE SITUATION
WILL INCREASE THE RISK OF
LITIGATION, IT MAY UNDERMINE THE
WILLINGNESS OF PROVIDERS TO
UNDERTAKE NEW DEPLOYMENTS OR NEW
PROVIDERS TO ENTER THE MARKET.
THE DISPARATE TREATMENT STANDARD
IS A BETTER STANDARD AND WOULD
PROVIDE AN ENFORCEABLE FRAMEWORK
IN CALIFORNIA, WITHOUT RELYING
ON THE DISPUTED ASPECTS OF THE
FCC RULE. UNDER THE DISPARATE
TREATMENT STANDARD, BROADBAND
PROVIDERS WOULD HAVE A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER THE LAW,
AND WHAT WOULD NOT FEAR THE RISK
OF UNWARRANTED LITIGATION, IT IS
SAID THAT DISPARATE TREATMENT
STANDARD IS TOO HIGH A BAR FOR
PUBLIC ATTORNEYS TO MEET, THAT
THEY WOULD NEED A SMOKING GUN TO
PROVIDE DISCRIMINATION.
CERTAINLY, WE ARE NOT SUGGESTING
THAT OUR PUBLIC ATTORNEYS ARE
NOT CAPABLE OF MEETING THE
CONSTITUTIONAL STANDARDS. A
DISPARATE TREATMENT STANDARD
DOES NOT REQUIRE A SMOKING GUN.
IN FACT, MERE CIRCUMSTANTIAL
EVIDENCE WOULD BE RELEVANT TO
PROVING INTENT. CURRENTLY,
CALIFORNIA HAS THE BENEFIT OF
BEING THE SEAT OF INVESTMENT FOR
THE TECHNOLOGY SECTOR, INCLUDING
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
POLICIES SUCH AS IMPOSING A
DISPARATE IMPACT STANDARD WILL
HAVE A CHILLING EFFECT REGARDING
GROWTH UPGRADES AND INNOVATION,
ENSURING ACCESS TO BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO EVERYONE, WHICH IS WHY
WE MUST OPPOSE AB 2239 AS IT
CONTINUES TO HAVE THE DISPARATE
IMPACT STANDARD, WHICH WILL HAVE
NEGATIVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
. THANK YOU. ONE MINUTE, 48
SECONDS. THAT'S VERY
PROFESSIONAL. I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO OUTDO YOUR I'M
TAKING ALL MY TIME. NO, BUT I'M
JUST SAYING I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
CAN DO YOUR SPEECH THIS MORNING,
BUT I'M CURIOUS TO SEE IF YOU
CAN ANYWAY. WELL, I'M GOING TO
ADJUST MINE A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE
I'M THE PASTOR ANDRE CHAPEL,
SENIOR PASTOR OF FAITH CHURCH,
LA IN THE CRENSHAW AREA AND
COMPTON, I GUESS I'M KIND OF
BLOWN AWAY THAT AND I LOOK
AROUND THE ROOM. THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT'S OBVIOUS HERE
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY
LIVING THIS REALITY OF ANY KIND
OF DISCRIMINATION RELATIVE TO
THE BLACK COMMUNITY, I'M KIND OF
LIKE THE ONLY ONE IN HERE, AND
I'M KIND OF BLOWN AWAY THAT, YOU
KNOW, EVERYBODY SPEAKING ABOUT
WHAT AFFECTS US. AND I'M IN THE
TRENCHES A COUPLE TIMES A WEEK
DOING WORKSHOPS WITH THE
COMMUNITY. I DON'T KNOW WHERE
THESE NUMBERS ABOUT THE INTERNET
AND BROADBAND STUFF ARE COMING
FROM, BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
REALISTIC FOR WHERE I, WHERE I
LIVE, WHERE I PASTOR, WHERE I
PREACH, LET ME BE CLEAR,
ENSURING THAT EVERY FAMILY,
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE OF COLOR, ARE
SERVED WITH QUALITY BROADBAND IS
VITAL TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA, BUT
FROM WHAT I'M LOOKING AT, THIS
BILL IS NOT GOING TO DO THAT, IN
FACT, IT'S GOING TO DO THE
OPPOSITE. IT ACTUALLY SLOWS
DOWN. THEY'RE DEPLOYING
BROADBAND FOR ALL AND LIKELY
WILL END PROGRAMS LIKE WHAT I
HOST FOR MY COMMUNITY, THAT THAT
I FIGHT FOR EVERY DAY. THE
PROBLEM WITH THE BILL IS THE
DEFINITION OF DISCRIMINATION, WE
KNOW THAT CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS HAVE
ALWAYS HISTORICALLY BEEN
DESIGNED TO FIX SITUATIONS WHERE
BAD ACTORS INTENTIONALLY,
INTENTIONALLY DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST PEOPLE BECAUSE OF WHO
THEY ARE. UNFORTUNATELY, THIS
BILL TRIES TO EXPAND THAT
DEFINITION, AND INSTEAD USE
DISPARATE IMPACT STANDARDS.
THAT'S GOING TO LIKELY RESULT IN
BROADBAND PROVIDERS BEING
SERVED, BIG LAWSUITS AND A LOT
OF PENALTIES, WHICH IS GOING TO
CAUSE THEM TO, YOU KNOW, PULL
BACK, JUST HAVING GOOD BUSINESS
PRACTICES. AND AT THE END OF THE
DAY, WITHOUT THE NOTES, I'M
REALLY IN FEAR THAT WE'LL LOSE
SUPPORT FOR THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
OPERATE. WE DON'T EXPECT THE
INTERNET PROVIDERS TO DO THE
WORK THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO DO
ON THE GROUND, BUT WE NEED WE
NEED THEM TO BE HAVE A HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP US DO IT.
AND SO I HEARD A COUPLE OF TIMES
THAT PEOPLE WEREN'T TOO WORRIED
ABOUT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. WELL, I'M THE
VICTIM OF THAT AND I'M WORRIED
ABOUT THAT. SO I HOPE YOU ALL
WOULD CONSIDER THE HEART OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE WHO ARE GOING
THROUGH THIS, YOU KNOW, EVERY
DAY AND, YOU KNOW, REWRITE THIS
OR SOMETHING. BUT AT THIS POINT,
RESPECTFULLY, WE WOULD HOPE
THAT, YOU WOULD OPPOSE IT. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, PASTOR, ANYONE
IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION,
PLEASE COME. IT'S NOW ME TO
TESTIMONY. NAME ORGANIZATION. IF
YOU HAVE ONE. AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL. HI. MEG SNYDER,
AXIOM ADVISORS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, YOLANDA BENSON
FOR US TELECOM, THE BROADBAND
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THIS TO 2239. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MR. JOHNSON. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER HISPANIC
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WELL DONE. COURTNEY
JENSEN, ON BEHALF OF CIVIL
JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, JONATHAN
ARAMBULA, ON BEHALF OF CTIA, THE
TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY, IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, ROXANNE
GOULD. WITH THE WIRELESS
INFRASTRUCTURE ASSOCIATION, A
WAY BETTER ASSOCIATION THAN HIS
IN OPPOSITION. DEAN TAYLOR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION OPPOSED.
THANK YOU SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON.
AUDRA HARTMAN ON BEHALF OF
QUALCOMM. WE'RE OPPOSED. THANK
YOU. LIZZY CUTRONA HERE ON
BEHALF OF TECHNET AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GREAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY. PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. AND I'M
SO GLAD YOU'RE HERE BECAUSE
YOU'RE GOING TO ENERGIZE US
THROUGH ALL THIS HEAT. SO
PLEASE, YOU'VE GOT THE FLOOR.
SENATOR STERN, I DON'T COUNT ME
FOR THAT, BUT JUST BRIEFLY,
SINCE WE HEARD THIS BILL EARLIER
IN ENERGY, I WANTED TO FOLLOW UP
ON WHAT SOUNDED LIKE A
PRODUCTIVE PATH I DID. I DID
UNDERSTAND THAT THE CHAIR AND
AUTHOR HAD A COLLOQUY ABOUT,
SCOPE OF ENFORCEMENT. SO IT
SOUNDS LIKE THAT THAT PIECE, I
GUESS, HAS BEEN ACCEPTED, THE
PIECE I WANTED TO SORT OF DRILL
DOWN ON, WAS WHAT YOU'RE WHAT
THE LEAD WITNESS WAS, WAS
TOUCHING ON STANDARDS OF PROOF
IN TERMS OF ESTABLISHING,
DISPARATE IMPACT. AND I WANTED
TO JUST YOU WERE YOU WERE ALMOST
THROUGH YOUR FACTORS, DURING THE
OPENING STATEMENT. BUT JUST TO
SUMMARIZE, I TOOK SOME NOTES ON
IT, BUT BUT THAT, THAT THE IDEA
THAT I HEARD A WILLINGNESS OR AN
OPENNESS TO, FROM, FROM THE
AUTHOR IS TO, IN MORE GRANULAR
DETAIL, SPECIFY WHAT THAT
STANDARD OF PROOF WOULD BE. AND
SPECIFICALLY WHAT THE FACTORS
WOULD BE TO ESTABLISH A PRIMA
FACIE CASE, BY, ACCURATELY AND
COMPLETELY IDENTIFYING THE
POLICY OR PRACTICE AT ISSUE,
ESTABLISHING THAT POLICY AT
ISSUE WAS A PROTECTED CLASS. SO
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE PROTECTED
CLASS IDENTIFICATION, AND THEN
ESTABLISHING SUFFICIENT HARM TO
CONSTITUTE A VIOLATION. AND THE
CAUSATION PIECE, THOSE ARE SORT
OF THE SORT OF FOUR KEY FACTORS
IN THAT PRIMA FACIE CASE. AND
THEN ONCE THE PLAINTIFF HAD
ESTABLISHED THAT, THEN THE
DEFENDANT MAY THEN RESPOND AND
THE BURDEN CAN SHIFT BACK, THAT
THEY CAN THEN, ESTABLISH THAT A
CHALLENGED POLICY OR PRACTICE IS
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE THE
SUBSTANTIAL, LEGITIMATE,
NONDISCRIMINATORY INTERESTS,
SOME OF WHICH WERE OUTLINED IN
THE ENERGY COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND THEN AN EVENT OF SUCH A
SHOWING THAT, THAT THE THAT THE
ACTION, THAT THE PLAINTIFF WOULD
HAVE TO SHOW THERE'S A, THERE
MUST SHOW THAT THERE'S A LESS
DISCRIMINATORY ALTERNATIVE. I
THINK YOU HAD SAID EXHAUSTING,
REASONABLE ALTERNATIVES OR
REASONABLY AVAILABLE OR
ACHIEVABLE ALTERNATIVES. I KNOW
THAT'S A LOT OF DETAIL, BUT I
WANTED TO EITHER AUTHOR OR
SPONSOR TO SEE IF THAT SEEMED
LIKE WE'RE ON THE RIGHT TRACK
AND SOMEWHERE WHERE WE COULD GO
SO THAT THESE FOLKS KNOW WHAT,
YOU KNOW WHAT'S COMING. AND WE
DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH A WHOLE
ROUND OF LITIGATION JUST TO
ESTABLISH A PROOF STANDARD, SO
AT LEAST WE COULD MAYBE CROSS
THAT BRIDGE STATUTORILY. EVEN
SOME OF THESE OTHER ISSUES ARE
GOING TO BE OUTSTANDING. SENATOR
I'LL ADDRESS, JUST AS A POINT OF
ORDER BEFORE I PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE, IF I MAY, SIR, I'M A
BLACK LATINA. I'M SITTING RIGHT
HERE. PERHAPS I WASN'T IN FRONT
OF IN FRONT OF YOU, BUT I DO
REPRESENT THE COMMUNITIES FROM
WHICH I COME FROM, AND I THINK
WE HEARD FROM MANY PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY WHO ARE BLACK AND
BROWN, WHO ARE SURE AND CERTAIN
TO KNOW THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE THIS LEGISLATION MOVE
FORWARD. AND YOU WERE ABLE TO
HEAR FROM THEM. JUST I'LL GO
BACK TO MY RESPONSE NOW. SENATOR
STERN, I THINK THAT YOU ARE
RIGHTFULLY ON THE KIND OF ON THE
RIGHT PATH. ONE OF THE POINTS OF
TENSION IN THIS LEGISLATION, AS
I UNDERSTAND IT, IS THAT, THE
FCC HAS THE KIND OF THE
REGULATORY FORCE TO BE ABLE TO
HEAR, HEAR CLAIMS AND KIND OF
AND, AND, AND REVIEW THEM. AND
WE'VE TAKEN A PATH THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATION THAT IS BASED ON THE
USE OR APPLICATION OF PUBLIC
ATTORNEYS TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
NOW, WITH THIS AMENDMENT, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, AND, AND WHAT
IT IS MISSING FROM WHAT WE'RE
ABLE TO DO IN TERMS OF
ARTICULATION OF DISPARATE IMPACT
IS ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A KIND OF
A PRE ARTICULATION OR A SET OF
FACTORS THAT WOULD GUIDE THE,
PUBLIC ATTORNEYS FROM FROM
REALLY CONSIDERING WHETHER OR
NOT WE ARE THEY HAVE A CASE THEY
WOULD DO THAT ANYWAY WHEN THEY
WERE ESTABLISHING THE FACTS OF
THE CASE. I THINK THE GUIDANCE
TO KIND OF PUT IN STATUTE THAT
WOULD ALLOW THAT TO BE HELD,
IT'S ALIGNED WITH
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION
JURISDICTION. LAW, AS WE KNOW
BEFORE, I DON'T I BELIEVE THAT
IT IS A VERY SMART AND
DELIBERATE WAY FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO KIND OF HAVE THAT INCLUDED IN
THE IN THE DETERMINATION IN THE
STATUTE. SO I WOULD BE
COMFORTABLE WITH PURSUING THAT.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, WE ARE ON
SUCH A TIGHT TIME FRAME, WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT.
HAD THE GREAT IDEA THIS MORNING,
IN UNI. AND SHOULD THIS BILL
MOVE OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE, I'M
COMMITTED TO EXPLORING THAT WITH
THAT COMMITMENT AND RECOGNIZING
THE CONSTRAINTS. AND THAT'S
TRICKY FOR MEMBERS, TOO, BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T HAVE EVERYTHING IN
WRITING HERE. THAT COMMITMENT
MEANS ENOUGH TO ME, I THINK, TO
KEEP MOVING THIS THIS BILL AND,
AND I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHENTICITY OF THE STORY YOU'RE
BRINGING. AND I WOULDN'T ALLOW
ANY TESTIMONY TO NEGATE THAT. WE
KNOW IT'S REAL. WE KNOW IT'S
REAL FOR PEOPLE OUT THERE, AND
IT'S NO DISRESPECT TO YOU, SIR,
BUT EVERYONE'S, YOU KNOW, YOU
CAN GET THE SHORT END OF THE
STICK ON ONE END AND DOESN'T
TAKE ANYTHING AWAY FROM THE
OTHER. RIGHT. SO, ANYHOW, THANK
YOU FOR THAT, SENATOR, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, YOU KNOW, WE
SOME OF US HAVEN'T HAD A LOT OF
TIME TO READ THIS ANALYSIS, BUT
BUT I'M SOMEWHAT FAMILIAR. I
USED TO BE FAMILIAR WITH
DISPARATE IMPACT IN THE
EMPLOYMENT AND OTHER SETTINGS
WHERE YOU SORT OF HAVE A IT'S
EASIER TO, YOU KNOW, FACIALLY
NEUTRAL POLICY POLICY THAT HAS A
DISPARATE IMPACT ON A ON MEMBERS
OF A PROTECTED GROUP. PRETTY
EASY TO UNDERSTAND THAT
UNINTENTIONAL DON'T INTEND IT,
BUT IT HAPPENS. SO YOU HAVE A
GROUP OF EMPLOYEES OR YOU HAVE A
GROUP OF STUDENTS IN A IN AN
EDUCATIONAL SETTING OR SOMEWHERE
ELSE. HOW DO YOU SEE THIS POLICY
WORKING WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE LAYING DOWN
BROADBAND, CABLE OR WHATEVER, IN
WIDE AREAS, WON'T THERE ALWAYS
BE A DISPARATE IMPACT SOMEWHERE?
AND EVERY TIME SOMEONE WANTS TO
EXPAND BROADBAND ACCESS IN A, IN
A LARGE AREA IS GOING TO LAY
SOME CABLE, WON'T THAT OPEN, I
HAVEN'T HAD A LOT OF TIME TO
THINK THROUGH THIS, WHICH IS WHY
I'M GOING TO SORT OF MAKE A
STATEMENT AND SORT OF ASK A
QUESTION. WON'T THAT ALWAYS OPEN
UP DISPARATE IMPACT CLAIMS,
BECAUSE ONE NEIGHBORHOOD OR ONE
REGION IS GOING TO CLAIM THAT
THE POLICY, IN THIS CASE, THE
DECISION TO LAY THIS BROADBAND
DOWN IS HAVING A DISPARATE
IMPACT. AND THEN THEN THEN WHAT?
NEUTRAL POLICY, DISPARATE
IMPACT. AND I GUESS YOU CAN
DEFEND IT BY DOING SOMETHING.
YOU CAN DEFEND IT BY, PROPOSING
THAT YOU HAVE A LEGITIMATE
BUSINESS INTEREST IN, IN BEING
ABLE TO DO SO OR THAT IT IS
TECHNICALLY INFEASIBLE OR, OR
ECONOMICALLY INFEASIBLE, THAT IS
A PART OF THIS, A PART OF THIS
LEGISLATION. AND THAT'S A LEGAL
PROCESS THAT I'M FAMILIAR WITH.
AND I'M ALSO FAMILIAR WITH THE
LENGTH OF TIME THAT IT TAKES TO
DO THESE THINGS. AND WE SEE WE
SEE THIS UNRELATED BUT DIFFICULT
PROCESS PLAY OUT IN SEQUA AND
DEVELOPMENT. ALL THE TIME. AND
I'M JUST WONDERING WHY THE
DECISION WAS MADE, I GUESS, TO
PUT, TALK ABOUT DISPARATE IMPACT
AS OPPOSED TO DISPARATE
TREATMENT, WHICH IS A MORE
INTENTIONAL. THERE'S SOME
INTENTIONALITY THERE WITH MAKING
A DECISION TO LAY A, YOU KNOW,
BROADBAND CABLE HERE AS OPPOSED
TO THERE. RIGHT. WELL, I'LL
BEGIN AND WOULD ASK THAT MY,
WITNESSES CERTAINLY RESPOND TO
THAT. RIGHT NOW, INTERNET
SERVICE IS AN ESSENTIAL,
ESSENTIAL NEED TO BE ABLE TO
FUNCTION. SO JUST AS GOING TO
SCHOOL IS JUST AS BEING ABLE TO
HOLD A JOB AND, AND HAVE A JOB
AND NOT BE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
IN, IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES. WE
BELIEVE I BELIEVE THAT MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
LOOK AT THE EXPERIENCE OF
COMMUNITIES AND TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO, HAVE COMMUNITIES,
YOU KNOW, SPEAK TO THE FACT THAT
THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE
THAT IS NOT ENSURING THAT THEY
HAVE WHAT THEY WHAT THEY NEED OR
WHAT THEY CAN, IN A PARTICULAR
SITUATION, WE HAVE OUR WITNESS
HERE, PATRICK MESICK FROM
OAKLAND UNDIVIDED, WHO IS ABLE
TO, THROUGH ADVOCACY AND THE
ORGANIZATION, PULL TOGETHER A
LOT OF DATA AROUND THE
DIFFERENTIAL EXPERIENCE THAT A
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY IS HAVING.
SO WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO HAVE
INSIGHT INTO THE FACT THAT SOME
PEOPLE ARE HAVING A DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCE. AND THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATION, WE ARE ABLE TO
ESSENTIALLY HAVE THAT CODIFIED
EXPERIENCE BE PUT THROUGH AN
ANALYSIS THAT DETERMINES WHETHER
OR NOT THAT EXPERIENCE IS LINKED
TO A PARTICULAR POLICY, AND
WHETHER THAT EXPERIENCE IS
SEVERE ENOUGH OR DIFFERENTIAL
ENOUGH THAT IT DESERVES THE, THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO, HAVE
A REMEDY AROUND THAT. SO WHAT'S
THE REMEDY? WELL, THE REMEDY IS
IN, IN ORDER TO PUT IT IN, THE
REMEDY IS IN INJUNCTIVE RELIEF.
SO, SO TO PERHAPS ON THE
DEPLOYMENT OR KIND OF MODIFY AS
CERTAINLY WE HAVE INSTANCES
WHERE, FIBER IS LAID, IT NEEDS
TO BE, IT NEEDS TO BE IMPROVED
UPON. AND WE HAVE AN
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT THAT
WE'RE MAKING IN THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WHERE THERE IS AN EVER
INCREASING, OR EVOLVING
DEPLOYMENT OF, OF SERVICES. SO
THAT WOULD BE ESSENTIALLY WHAT
THE INJUNCTIVE RELIEF WOULD BE
TO HELP TO FIX THE PROBLEM OR TO
ENSURE IT IS IF IT'S A IF IT'S
TIED TO A PARTICULAR PRACTICE OR
POLICY THAT WE KNOW LED TO THAT
DISCRIMINATORY IMPACT. I DON'T
KNOW IF I JUST QUESTION WHETHER
THE WRAPPING THERE IS A PROBLEM.
WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT IT IN
THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE HAVING
TO DO WITH ONLINE EDUCATION AND
WHETHER STUDENTS COULD WHY
COULDN'T THEY TAKE A SERIES OF
COURSES THAT HAPPENED TO BE
NURSING COURSES ONLINE? AND VERY
GOOD QUESTION. AND OF COURSE
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO. BUT THE
PROBLEM IS IN SOME AREAS OF THE
STATE, THERE'S LIMITED BROADBAND
ACCESS AND RELIABLE, RELIABLE
ACCESS. AND SO THAT MAKES IT
VERY DIFFICULT IF YOU'RE TRYING
TO GET THROUGH AN EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM WHEN HALF OF YOUR COURSE
DISAPPEARS AND YOU CAN'T, YOUR
CLASS AND YOU CAN'T GET THE
CLASS. SO I'M A FIRM BELIEVER IS
WE NEED TO FIGURE THIS OUT. I'M
JUST WONDERING IF WRAPPING THIS
IN THE IN THE IN THE CLOTH OF,
DISCRIMINATION AND DISPARATE
IMPACT AS OPPOSED TO INTENTIONAL
DISCRIMINATION, DISCRIMINATORY
TREATMENT WHERE, BROADBAND
COMPANIES MAKE A DECISION, YOU
KNOW, THEY'RE NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE.
THEY'RE THEY DON'T MAKE ENOUGH
MONEY. THEY CAN'T PAY OUR BILLS.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SUBSIDIZE THE
SERVICE, WHICH WOULD BE
TREATMENT PROBABLY INTENTIONAL.
PROBABLY. WELL AS OPPOSED TO BUT
AS OPPOSED TO DECIDING THAT, YOU
KNOW, IT'S MORE CONVENIENT TO GO
OVER HERE OR IT'S CHEAPER FOR US
TO PUT THE LINE OVER HERE, AS
OPPOSED TO WHICH WOULD BE A
NEUTRAL POLICY, BUT COULD HAVE A
DISPARATE IMPACT. FACIALLY
NEUTRAL POTENTIALLY. AND THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE SEEKING
TO DO, ENSURE THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE WHOLE
COMMUNITIES SPEAK TO THE
DISCRIMINATION OR THE
DIFFERENTIAL EXPERIENCE THAT
THEY'RE HAVING, AND HAVE THAT
ORIENTED AROUND HOW THEY MIGHT
BE ABLE TO HAVE, OUR ISP
PROVIDERS AND COVERED ENTITIES
REMEDY THAT. WE AND I MISS BETTY
, WHO I MET, ON A TOUR, HAS NO
IDEA WHY HER INTERNET SERVICE
ISN'T WORKING. MISS BETTY AND
HER NEIGHBORS HAVE NO IDEA WHY
HER INTERNET SERVICE ISN'T
WORKING, WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO KIND OF
UNPACK THAT. WE, AS INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE GOING THROUGH THIS
EXPERIENCE DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GO UP AGAINST THE
GOLIATH OF INDUSTRY TO BE ABLE
TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER OR NOT THE
EXPERIENCE THAT THEY'RE HAVING
IS NOT ONE THAT THEY SHOULD BE
HAVING BECAUSE OF SOME KIND OF
PRACTICE OR POLICY RELATED TO,
TO THAT EXPERIENCE. AND THAT IS
WHY WE ARE FOCUSED ON DISPARATE
IMPACT. I'M GOING TO ASK MY
WITNESSES TO PIPE IN ON THIS
ONE. YEAH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ROTH. JUST VERY BRIEFLY,
I WOULD URGE US TO THINK ABOUT
THESE SYSTEMS OVER TIME. WE HAVE
30 YEARS OF BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT
THAT IS LEFT BEHIND. SYSTEMATIC
GAPS BUILD OUT IS CONSISTENTLY
OVER TIME, BYPASSING COMMUNITIES
, MAJORITY MADE UP OF PROTECTED
CLASSES. IF WE'RE LOOKING FOR A
REALLY CONCRETE EXAMPLE, WE CAN
LOOK TO CONCRETE PRICING
DISPARITIES. THESE ARE PULLED UP
FROM VERY RECENTLY. YOU CAN LOOK
AT ADDRESSES BY THE SAME COMPANY
FOR THE SAME SPEED PLAN, NOT BUT
A MILE AWAY. YOU'RE GETTING
COSTS THAT ARE $20 HIGHER. SO
SUPPOSED TO GET PERMISSION
BEFORE YOU USE A PRODUCT? OH MY
APOLOGIES, I DIDN'T REALIZE
THAT. NO, I'M GOING TO ALLOW.
OKAY. I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT, SO I
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE US TO THINK
ABOUT THE PATTERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN WELL DOCUMENTED FOR
DECADES, INCLUDING THE CPUC
NETWORK EXAM, WHICH SHOWS
DISPARATE INVESTMENT IN HIGHER
INCOME COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE TO
START LOOKING AT THIS, AS A 30
YEAR PROBLEM IN THE MAKING, THAT
WE CAN BEGIN TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE MOST EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES.
ISN'T THIS ISN'T THIS REGULATED
BY THE CPUC? I DON'T REMEMBER
WHO WHO HANDLES BROADBAND. I CAN
RESPOND TO THAT AS SOMEONE WHO'S
BEEN PRACTICING AT THE CPUC.
PERFECT. I'M SORRY, YOU'RE ON.
SO IT'S CPUC AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY HAVE, HANDLED
BROADBAND OR. WELL, MY QUESTION
IS, WHY ISN'T THIS, YOU KNOW,
WHY ISN'T THIS BEING HANDLED IN
THAT CONTEXT AS OPPOSED TO
WRAPPING IT IN THE CLOTH OF
DISCRIMINATION AND HAVING TO
DEAL WITH DISPARATE, DISPARATE,
DISPARATE IMPACT ANALYSIS? WHAT
I THINK IS GOING TO HAPPEN,
FRANKLY, IS I THINK, THESE
COMPANIES AND THE PROPOSALS ARE
GOING TO BE IN ADDITION TO THE
PUC PROCESS AND EVERYTHING THAT
GOES ON OR DOESN'T GO ON, THERE
ARE GOING TO BE WRAPPED IN A
DISCRIMINATION, PROCESS. AND
DISPARATE TREATMENT IS EASIER TO
PROCESS, PROSECUTE AND EASIER TO
DEFEND. IF YOU HAVE A DEFENSE.
DISPARATE IMPACT IS SORT OF
DIFFICULT. DISPARATE IMPACT IS
ALSO MORE DIFFICULT TO ACTUALLY
ESTABLISH. IT IS MORE DIFFICULT
TO ESTABLISH TO WHICH WHICH
WHICH WOULD ADDS TO THE PROBLEM,
ADDS TO THE LENGTH OF THE
PROCESS, BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO I I'M NOT GOING TO
BELABOR THIS, MR. CHAIR, BUT I
HAVE SOME CONCERNS. YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH I RESPECT YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
SO I JUST WANTED TO ASK MY
QUESTIONS. I'M GOING TO STOP.
ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. APPRECIATE THE PATIENCE.
I APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION.
SENATOR ASHBY. YES. HI.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN. HOW ARE YOU
DOING? THANK YOU. THIS IS THE
SECOND TIME TODAY THAT I HAVE
SEEN YOU PRESENT THIS BILL. AND
I KNOW THE MAKEUP OF THIS
COMMITTEE. MAY NOT MAKE YOU FEEL
RIGHT AT HOME, BUT HAD YOU SEEN
HER EARLIER TODAY? THE
CHAIRPERSON OF THAT COMMITTEE,
LOOKS JUST LIKE YOU. AND LIVES
IN LOS ANGELES, Tê, AND ALSO
SUPPORTED HER BILL. AND SHE
WORKED HEAVILY WITH HIM ON
AMENDMENTS AS WELL. AND, AND
THEN I JUST, I WANT TO SAY A
COUPLE OF THINGS BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, THIS THIS BILL IS TOUGH,
BUT WE'RE IN HERE TO GRAPPLE
WITH THE TOUGH ISSUES. AND I
REPRESENT SACRAMENTO. AND, I'M
WHITE, OBVIOUSLY, BUT I LIVED IN
LOW INCOME HOUSING IN THIS CITY
THAT I NOW GET TO BE THE SENATOR
FOR. AND I RAISED A LITTLE BOY
BY MYSELF, AND I USED FOOD
STAMPS, AND I PUT MYSELF THROUGH
LAW SCHOOL AND UNDERGRAD. AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT YOU KNOW,
WHERE YOU LIVE IN THIS TOWN.
THERE'S A REALLY BIG DIFFERENCE
IN YOUR LIFE EXPECTANCY,
SOMETIMES JUST EVEN FIVE MINUTES
APART. I GET TO LIVE IN THIS
REALLY NICE COMMUNITY NOW CALLED
NATOMAS. BUT IF YOU DRIVE FIVE
MINUTES FROM ME TO DEL PASO
HEIGHTS, YOUR LIFE EXPECTANCY
DROPS OVER A DECADE. AND SOME OF
IT HAS TO DO WITH ACCESS TO
RESOURCES. AND WHILE THERE ARE
MANY DEFINITIONS IN HERE THAT
ARE A BIT CHALLENGING, I THINK
SHE'S ONE BY ONE WORKING HER WAY
THROUGH THEM. SENATOR ROTH,
SHE'S JUST ONE BY ONE, JUST
TRYING TO PRESS FORWARD THROUGH
A PROCESS THAT THAT MAKES IT SO
THAT SOUTH CENTRAL LA AND SO
THAT, DEL PASO HEIGHTS AND OAK
PARK AND GOD BLESS HER, OAKLAND
DON'T GET LEFT BEHIND BECAUSE
IT'S WHEN BIG COMPANIES COME IN.
AND THIS IS NO FAULT OF THEM.
THIS IS NOT A CRITICISM OF BIG
COMPANIES. IT'S EASY TO ADD
RESOURCES IN FANCY COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO UTILIZE
IT AND THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE
MONEY THERE. BUT WE HAVE A DUTY
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY IN
CALIFORNIA CAN ACCESS THE
INTERNET, THAT THEY CAN GET TO
THOSE RESOURCES. I MEAN, THINK
ABOUT ALL THE THINGS OUR LIVES
ARE TOTALLY DEPENDENT ON IT,
RIGHT NOW. AND WHEN COVID
HAPPENED, IS THERE ANYTHING WE
LEARNED MORE THAN THAT? ACCESS
WAS A LIFELINE, ESPECIALLY FOR
KIDS. I KNOW JUST LIKE MANY
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM AND SOME OF
THE PEOPLE, WHO RIGHT NOW ARE
STRUGGLING WITH HER BILL WERE
SOME OF OUR BEST ACTORS,
ACTUALLY, IN HELPING US MAKE
SURE WE FOUND EVERY KID AND WE
GOT THEM COMPUTERS AND WE GOT
THEM INTERNET. I MEAN, HARD FOR
ME TO EVEN THINK OF SOMEBODY IN
SACRAMENTO WHO DID MORE THAN
COMCAST. THEY WERE REALLY
HELPFUL. SO THIS IS JUST ONE
MORE WAY OF GRAPPLING WITH THE
ISSUE OF DISPARITY AND TRYING TO
FIND PATHWAYS WHILE WE'RE HERE
IN THIS SPACE, WHILE THE PEOPLE
LIKE US ARE HERE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HELP AS MANY COMMUNITIES
AS POSSIBLE, PUT THEM ON A
TRAJECTORY TO SUCCESS. ONE GREAT
THING ABOUT THE LEGISLATURE IS
THAT THIS WILL KEEP SHE'LL KEEP
WORKING ON THIS ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE SUMMER. SHE'S GOT
MORE TIME ON THE CLOCK. THERE
MIGHT BE SOME THINGS SHE CAN
ADDRESS WITH WITH FOLKS BEFORE
IT COMES UP FOR A FINAL VOTE.
AND EVEN NEXT YEAR, IF SHE
NEEDED TO, SHE COULD RUN ANOTHER
BILL OR SO COULD SOMEBODY ELSE.
SO COULD MR. BRYANT. SO COULD I,
IF THERE WAS SOME PIECE OF THIS
THAT WE NEEDED TO ADJUST OR ADD
ON TO. AND SO FOR ALL OF THOSE
REASONS, NOT ONLY AM I
SUPPORTING YOU TODAY, BUT I'M
REALLY PROUD OF YOU. THANK YOU.
MOTION. YES. GREAT ANY OTHER
COMMENTS? SEEING NONE, AND WE
CLOSE. WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION THAT WE'VE HAD
INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU TO
SENATOR ASHBY. AND SENATORS ROTH
AND THE COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR
BEING ABLE TO AFFORD US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE IN THIS
MOMENT. I, WORKED AS A
CONSULTANT FOR THE FCC,
DEVELOPING OUT THE NATIONAL
BROADBAND INITIATIVE FOR
EDUCATION. IT'S WHERE I STARTED
ALMOST 20 YEARS AGO, KIND OF
ENGAGED IN THIS WORK. MORE
IMPORTANTLY, I WORKED FOR
SEVERAL YEARS HANDING OUT
TABLETS TO MOTHERS, TO BE ABLE
TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAD, THE
MEANS TO BE ABLE TO, HAVE THEIR
CHILDREN ENGAGE IN STRONGER
EARLY LEARNING EXPERIENCES AT A
SHOP IN WEST OAKLAND, WHERE WE
WERE RUNNING THOUSANDS OF
TABLETS WHERE WE PARTNERED WITH
AMAZING, ISP PROVIDERS LIKE
COMCAST AND AT&T TO OFFER, MORE
AFFORDABLE INTERNET SERVICES AND
THE SENT THE CENTER WHERE I
WORKED DIDN'T HAVE THE ABILITY
TO, DO THE UPLOADING AND
DOWNLOADING OF THE APPS THAT WE
WERE TRYING TO LOAD ONTO OUR
DEVICES BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE
ADEQUATE INTERNET SERVICE. THIS
IS DEEPLY PERSONAL TO ME. IT'S
DEEPLY PERSONAL TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT I REPRESENT AND
THE REASON WHY I BELIEVE WE NEED
TO HAVE THIS HIGHER STANDARD OF
DISPARATE IMPACT AND TO BE ABLE
TO LOOK AT THIS FROM A LENS OF
WHETHER OR NOT THERE IS EXISTS
DISCRIMINATION AT ANY POINT IN
TIME AROUND THIS ESSENTIAL
SERVICE IS BECAUSE IT'S JUST AS
ESSENTIAL AS OUR EDUCATION. IT'S
JUST AS ESSENTIAL AS ENSURING
THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO HAVE A JOB.
IT'S JUST AS ESSENTIAL AS
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE A HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM THAT ISN'T
DISCRIMINATORY, AND THIS IS OUR
TIME. GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
FCC HAS ALREADY PASSED A
REGULATION THAT MIRRORS THIS
BILL TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY CALIFORNIAN HAS THE
ABILITY TO RECEIVE, ACCESS TO,
THE INTERNET, AND TO DO SO IN A
WAY THAT ALLOWS THEM AND AFFORDS
OUR COMMUNITIES OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES, A REMEDY
THAT SIGNALS THAT WE ARE
PROTECTING THIS RESOURCE WITH
ALL OUR MIGHT, GIVEN THE MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF INVESTMENTS THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS MAKING TO
ENSURE BROADBAND FOR ALL. AND
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
BY SENATOR ASHBY. ALL RIGHT,
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM 58 AB
2239. THE MOTION IS TO PASS IS
AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG. I
UMBERG. AYE. WILK WILK. NO.
ALLEN. ASHBY. ASHBY AYE.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE
RUSSELL. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE LILO.
NO. LILO. NO. ROTH STERN. WAHAB
4 TO 2. 4 TO 2. WE'RE GOING TO
PUT THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. CHAIR ALL RIGHT
I SEE WHO'S NEXT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALL I SEE ASSEMBLY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL HERE. IF
NOT, THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONLEY
. ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONLEY, WELCOME TO THE OVEN. WE
WERE FOREWARNED BY TV. THANK
YOU, SENATOR LAIRD. ALL RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONLEY, ITEM 51
AB 2149. THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, WE'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL, AND I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. MEMBERS,
TODAY, I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB
2149, WHICH WILL BE KNOWN AS THE
ALEX COHEN BACKED GATE SAFETY
ACT IN 2019. WE SUFFERED A
TRAGEDY IN MARIN COUNTY, SEVEN
YEAR OLD ALEX SCHWANBECK WAS AT
A SCHOOL PLAYING WITH HIS
FRIENDS AND WENT TO CLOSE A 300
POUND GATE TO STOP THEIR
FOOTBALL FROM ROLLING INTO THE
NEARBY ALLEY. AS HE STARTED TO
ROLL, THE GATE CLOSED. THE GATE
CAME OFF ITS RAILS AND FELL AND
CRUSHED ALEX, KILLING HIM. THIS
UNFORTUNATELY, IS A NOT UNCOMMON
OCCURRENCE IN CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. JUST
LAST NOVEMBER, TRAGEDY STRUCK
AGAIN IN TUCSON, ARIZONA, WHEN A
NINE YEAR OLD GIRL WAS HELPING
CLOSE A GATE AT HER SCHOOL,
WHICH CAME LOOSE FROM ITS
SUPPORT AND FELL AND KILLED HER.
THERE ARE NO EXISTING STATEWIDE
OR FEDERAL LAWS REQUIRING HEAVY
DUTY GATES TO BE INSPECTED OR
REPAIRED ON A REGULAR BASIS,
WITHOUT ANY PROTECTIONS. WHEN A
GATE IS POORLY DESIGNED, DAMAGED
OR JUST OVERUSED, IT HAS A RISK
OF DISCONNECTING FROM ITS
SUPPORTS AND FALLING. THESE
GATES CAN BE UP TO 20 OR 30FT
LONG AND UP TO EIGHT FEET TALL.
THEY OFTEN WEIGH BETWEEN 300 TO
400 POUNDS, MAKING IT ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE FOR SOMEONE CRUSHED
UNDERNEATH TO LIFT THE GATE AND
ESCAPE. AB 2149 CALLS FOR THESE
GATES TO BE INSTALLED, WITH
WHAT'S KNOWN AS A POSITIVE STOP,
LITERALLY A $50 PIECE OF METAL
THAT STOPS THE GATE FROM
TOPPLING OVER. IF IT BECOMES
SEPARATED FROM ITS TRACK. THIS
BILL ONLY APPLIES TO GATES THAT
WEIGH MORE THAN 50 POUNDS AND
LARGER THAN FOUR FEET WIDE, OR
SEVEN FEET TALL. THE BILL, AS
AMENDMENT AS AMENDED, WILL NOW
ONLY APPLY TO GATES CURRENTLY
INSTALLED IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
PARKS. GOING FORWARD. THESE
REQUIREMENTS WILL BE APPLIED TO
ALL NEW GATES INTENDED FOR USE
BY THE PUBLIC. AN ENTIRE
COMMUNITY OR NEIGHBORHOOD, OR
ANY CONSIDERABLE NUMBER OF
PERSONS. IT WILL BE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE GATE OWNER
TO MAKE SURE THEIR GATE IS
INSPECTED AT LEAST ONCE. NO LESS
THAN EVERY TEN YEARS, AND LOCAL
BUILDING OFFICIALS WILL ONLY
HAVE TO BECOME INVOLVED IN
EGREGIOUS CASES. THE BILL ALSO
GIVES LOCAL BUILDING OFFICIALS
AND BUILDING DEPARTMENTS THE
ABILITY TO RECOUP COSTS OF THE
BILL THROUGH FINES AGAINST THE
GATE OWNER FOR FAILING TO HAVE
THEIR GATE INSPECTED AND
REPAIRED IN A TIMELY MANNER. WE
HAVE WORKED TO TRY AND APPLY
THIS BILL TO THOSE GATES THAT
ARE LIKELY TO IMPACT THE PUBLIC
AT LARGE. I'M COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS BILL
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS. WHILE STILL
ENSURING THAT THE PUBLIC AND OUR
CHILDREN ARE PROTECTED FROM
THESE TRAGIC ACCIDENTS. WITH ME
TO TESTIFY TODAY IS ERIC
SCHWANBECK, THE FATHER OF ALEX
SCHWANBECK AND CO-FOUNDER OF THE
HUMMINGBIRD ALLIANCE, AND ERIC
BLEDSOE WITH THE AMERICAN FENCE
ASSOCIATION PARTY. THANK YOU,
MR. COHEN. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO
THANK YOU, CHAIRMAN UMBERG AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, FOR ALLOWING
ME TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY. AND
ASSEMBLYMAN CONNELLY FOR HIS
CONTINUED ADVOCACY. WHILE MY
WIFE AND I ARE HERE SUPPORTING
THIS PROPOSED LEGISLATION IN
HONOR OF OUR SEVEN YEAR OLD SON,
ALEX. THE WORK WE ARE DOING AT
THE HUMMINGBIRD ALLIANCE IS
INTENDED TO SAVE LIVES. SINCE
STARTING OUR ORGANIZATION, WE
HAVE UNCOVERED NEARLY 20
FATALITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
FROM FALLING GATES, INCLUDING
THE RECENT DEATH. OVER THE PAST
FEW WEEKS OF AN EMPLOYEE AT A
LUMBERYARD IN ANAHEIM,
CALIFORNIA, WHO WAS CRUSHED BY
AN IRON GATE THAT WAS SO HEAVY
IT NEEDED TO BE LIFTED OFF THE
EMPLOYEE WITH A FORKLIFT. THERE
IS A SIMPLE AND SENSIBLE
SOLUTION TO ADDRESS THE DANGERS
THAT THESE LARGE GATES POSE TO
OUR COMMUNITIES. A STANDARDS
ORGANIZATION KNOWN AS ASTM HAS A
SET OF TECHNICAL SPECIFICATIONS
THAT ARE DESIGNED TO PREVENT
GATES FROM CAUSING FATALITIES
WHEN THEY FAIL. THESE VOLUNTARY
STANDARDS ARE CONSIDERED BEST
PRACTICES BY INDUSTRY
PROFESSIONALS. OUR GOAL WITH
THIS BILL IS TO SIMPLY TAKE
THESE ASTM STANDARDS AND CODIFY
THEM INTO LAW. NO GATE IS EVER
DESIGNED TO FAIL. HOWEVER, GIVEN
THE MECHANICAL MECHANISM THAT
ENABLES A GATE TO OPEN AND CLOSE
A ROLLING SET OF WHEELS OR A
SWINGING HINGE, THERE IS ALWAYS
A POSSIBILITY THAT A GATE
MALFUNCTIONS. WHEN THIS DOES
OCCUR, IT IS PARAMOUNT THAT
GATES HAVE A SIMPLE $50 SAFETY
DEVICE KNOWN AS A FALSE STOP
POST, WHICH PREVENTS A GATE FROM
FALLING TO THE GROUND. THIS
SAFETY DEVICE SHOULD BECOME AS
UBIQUITOUS AS A CAR SEATBELT, A
POOL FENCE, OR EVEN A FIRE
EXTINGUISHER. WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK TO FIND
COMPROMISE ON THIS ISSUE, AND WE
ARE ALSO COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION, GIVEN THEIR
CONCERNS OVER THE BURDEN OF
COMPLIANCE. WHILE THIS BILL WILL
APPLY TO EXISTING GATES ON
SCHOOL GROUNDS AND PUBLIC PARKS,
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT THAT THESE
ASTM STANDARDS BECOME
COMMONPLACE WITH NEW GATE
INSTALLATIONS. SIMPLY PUT, THE
COST OF THESE SAFEGUARD DEVICES
IS MINIMAL WHEN COMPARED TO THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE LOSS OF A LOVED
FAMILY MEMBER. AS MY WIFE AND I
HAVE EXPERIENCED FIRSTHAND AND
MANY OTHER FAMILIES ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY HAVE ALSO EXPERIENCED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND THE
WORK WE ARE DOING IN HONOR OF
OUR SON, ALEX. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR TURNING THIS
INCREDIBLE PAIN INTO GOOD. SO
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU. GO
AHEAD SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS ERIC BLEDSOE AND I'M A
PROFESSIONAL SECURITY CONTRACTOR
. AND I'M REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN FENCE ASSOCIATION. AND
THE ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS THIS
LEGISLATION. IT SUPPORTS IT
BECAUSE IT'S NEEDED. I
PERSONALLY INVESTIGATED THREE
ACCIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
LAST FOUR YEARS. ONE OF THEM WAS
ALEX SCHWANBECK. AND VERY SIMPLY
OF STOP POST OR OTHER SAFETY
DEVICES WOULD HAVE PREVENTED HIS
DEATH. THE OTHER CASES WERE LIFE
CHANGING FOR THE OTHER VICTIMS
OF THIS. SO FINANCIALLY THERE'S
VERY LITTLE BURDEN. IF THE GATE
CAN MOVE, IT CAN FALL. IT'S BEEN
PROVEN. WE SEE IT. THERE'S NO
REGULATION. WE NEED SOMETHING.
PLEASE. SERIOUSLY PASS THIS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
AB 2149, PLEASE APPROACH. SEEING
NO ONE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE, LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 2149, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON. I THINK IF YOU
JUST SPEAK A LITTLE LOUDER,
IT'LL. NOEL KRAMER IS WITH WINE
INSTITUTE. FIRST, I WANT TO
OFFER MY CONDOLENCES TO THE
SCHWANBECK FAMILY. I'M A MOTHER.
I WOULD NEVER WANT TO IMAGINE
THE TRAGEDY AND PAIN THAT
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, WE UNFORTUNATELY,
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THE
RIGHT WAY TO ADDRESS THIS IS TO
FOCUS ON SAFETY STANDARDS. WHEN
GATES ARE INSTALLED, RIGHT NOW,
THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH STANDARDS BOARD IS
REVIEWING A PETITION TO EXPAND
REGULATIONS FOR GATE SAFETY,
ALSO, THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION IS LOOKING AT NEW
BUILDING CODE REQUIREMENTS.
THOSE ARE THE PROPER PLACES TO
PUT NEW STANDARDS FOR GATES IN
PLACE RIGHT NOW. THE WAY THE
BILL IS DRAFTED, WE APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE, THAT
ARE BEING TAKEN TODAY. HOWEVER,
THEY ADD EVEN MORE CONFUSION
HAVING TO DETERMINE AND DOCUMENT
WHEN A GATE WAS INSTALLED WILL
BE CHALLENGING FOR OUR MEMBER
WINERIES. SO CALIFORNIA HAS
APPROXIMATELY 6200 WINERIES,
MOST OF THEM THROUGHOUT THE
STATE, HAVE GATES. OF THOSE 6200
WINERIES, THE BUREAU OF LABOR
STATISTICS ESTIMATES THAT
APPROXIMATELY 4000 HAVE NINE OR
FEWER EMPLOYEES, SO TO TRY AND
KEEP TRACK OF IF THIS GATE NEEDS
TO BE INSPECTED BECAUSE IT WAS
INSTALLED AFTER 2025, OR IF IT
DOESN'T NEED TO BE INSPECTED
BECAUSE IT WAS INSTALLED PRIOR,
WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT BURDEN ON
THESE SMALL BUSINESSES. SO WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE, TO NARROW
THE BILL, APPLY IT TO PLACES
WHERE CHILDREN ARE PRESENT, LIKE
SCHOOLS AND PARKS, AND LEAVE THE
OTHER GATES UP TO THE NEW
BUILDING STANDARDS CODE AND CAL
OSHA STANDARDS THAT ARE, UNDER
DEVELOPMENT. WITH THAT, WE URGE
YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS, MARK NEUBERGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. I AS WELL DEFINITELY
EXTEND MY CONDOLENCES FOR THE
LOSS AND THE TRAGEDY THAT
OCCURRED TO THE FAMILY. TRULY,
THAT DAY WAS A VERY LARGE
TRAGEDY AT THE MARK DAY SCHOOL,
AND I DEFINITELY HAD A CHANCE TO
TALK TO THE SPONSOR BEFORE. AND
I, AS A FATHER, ALSO SHARE MANY
OF THE SAME ACTIVITIES THAT HE
SHARES WITH HIS CHILDREN. AND OF
COURSE, THE TRAGIC PASSING OF
HIS SON. HOWEVER, OUR CONCERNS
ON THIS BILL STEM FROM THE
BROADNESS OF THE CURRENT VERSION
AND THE PROPOSED AMENDED VERSION
AS DRAFTED, THE BILL STILL
CAPTURES A WIDE NUMBER OF GATES
GIVEN THE LANGUAGE OF BEING
INTENDED TO BE USED BY THE
PUBLIC. A COMMUNITY OR A
NEIGHBORHOOD. FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN
DOES A NEW OR EXISTING
RESIDENTIAL SMALL BUSINESS GATE
BECOME REGULATED? ONCE THE
NEIGHBORHOOD BOOK CLUB MEETS IN
YOUR YARD? WHEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY LITTLE LEAGUE TEAM
PLAY WITH YOUR CHILDREN THE
EVENING YOU INVITE A
CONSIDERABLE NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO
A WEDDING RECEPTION OR OTHER
CELEBRATION EVENT IN YOUR
BACKYARD, THE BROADNESS OF THE
BILL OPENS UP A WIDE UNIVERSITY
UNIVERSE OF GATES TO ITS
APPLICABILITY. SPECIFICALLY, WE
BELIEVE THE BROADNESS OF THE
BILL WILL ENABLE PREDATORY
BEHAVIOR ON THE PART OF THE
INDUSTRY THAT STANDS TO BENEFIT
FROM ITS PROVISIONS AT THE
EXPENSE OF RESIDENTS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES. UNDER THIS BILL,
PRIVATE INDUSTRY CONTRACTORS ARE
THE PRIMARY DRIVING FORCE THAT
WILL ENFORCE THIS STATUTE. IF
YOU DISAGREE WITH THE PRIVATE
INSPECTORS ASSESSMENT OF YOUR
GATE, THAT IS A COVERED GATE BY
THIS BILL, THEY HAVE THE
STATUTORY COVER UNDER THIS BILL
TO INVOLVE THE COUNTY OR CITY TO
ENFORCE THEIR ESTIMATE. AT THIS
POINT, THE HOMEOWNER OR SMALL
BUSINESS HAS THREE CHOICES. PAY
THE CONTRACTOR TO WHOM THEY
DISAGREED. EITHER INSTALL A NEW
GATE OR REPLACE AN EXISTING
GATE, TAKE DOWN THE GATE, OR
REFUSE TO INSTALL A NEW GATE, OR
CONTINUE TO DISAGREE WITH CIVIL
PENALTIES FROM A CITY ATTORNEY
OR DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO
ACCOMPLISH THE GOALS OF THE
SPONSOR IS SEEKING. WE BELIEVE
THE TYPES OF GATES AND OWNERS
IMPACTED SHOULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY
LIMITED BEYOND THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED TODAY. I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND YOUR STAFF
FOR MEETING WITH ME, AS WELL AS
THE COMMITTEE STAFF, BUT I DO
WANT TO SAY WE REMAIN OPPOSED,
UNLESS AMENDED, AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS OUTLINED HERE AND IN
OUR LETTER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO,
AB 2149, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE, GIVE US YOUR NAME,
YOUR AFFILIATION, YOUR POSITION.
HI. MEG SNYDER, AXIOM ADVISORS,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION,
OPPOSED. GOOD AFTERNOON, ANTHONY
TANNEHILL WITH CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION,
ALSO WITH PORTFOLIO FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF REC
AND PARK DISTRICTS AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
BRADY, AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN A
RESPECTFUL OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING. SASHA HOROWITZ LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED.
THE APPLICATION OF THESE RULES
FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES IS NOT
THE SAME AS FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. AND THAT NEEDS TO BE
CLARIFIED IN THE BILL FOR IT TO
WORK. GOOD EVENING, SABRINA
DEMAYO LOCKHART, CALIFORNIA
ATTRACTIONS AND PARKS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSE, UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. TRACY RYAN,
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WITH AN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED AS WELL.
CHRISTINA DECARO, REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA SKI INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND GRANITE
CONSTRUCTION. WE REMAIN OPPOSED.
THANK YOU, CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE PLACER COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. HE AND PADILLA, WITH THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. MR. CHAIRMAN,
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, LOUIS
BROWN, ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE
IN OPPOSITION. GOOD EVENING.
MADISON DWELLEY, ON BEHALF OF
THE FAMILY WINEMAKERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. NICOLE
WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY, IN OPPOSITION
. DEAN TALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION OPPOSED
ANALY AUGUSTINE ON BEHALF OF
MESA WATER DISTRICT AND THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. ALSO, THE CALIFORNIA
GRAIN AND FEED ASSOCIATION,
CALIFORNIA SEED ASSOCIATION, AND
A VARIETY OF OTHER AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATIONS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATOR
RUSSELL. YES THANK YOU. HAVE A
FEW QUESTIONS. I ACTUALLY AM I'M
SORRY IF I MISSED YOUR
PRESENTATION AND WHATEVER
CONVERSATIONS HAVE GONE BACK AND
FORTH. SO THIS MIGHT BE A REPEAT
. BUT WITH REGARDS TO THIS, THE
CONDITIONS, THE MAINTENANCE OF
GATES, I'M SURE IT'S DIFFERENT
DEPENDING ON WHERE THE GATE IS,
BUT LET'S JUST TAKE SCHOOLS
BECAUSE THAT'S THAT'S LIKE ON
EVERYBODY'S MIND IS THE SCHOOLS.
WHAT WHAT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE SCHOOLS? SCHOOL DISTRICT
MANAGEMENT, ADMINISTRATION,
PRINCIPALS? I DON'T KNOW WHO,
BUT WHAT IS THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
RIGHT NOW WITH REGARDS TO GATES,
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME,
GOVERNMENT INSTITUTIONS LIKE
THAT, IT SHOULD BE AN EASY THING
THAT THEY DO, BUT I DON'T KNOW
IF THEY'RE REQUIRED TO DO IT. IF
THEY DO IT IN PRACTICE, I JUST
IT JUST SEEMS SO STRANGE THAT
THEY WOULDN'T. YEAH, IT'S A
GREAT QUESTION. SO, WHAT THIS
WOULD DO IS EFFECTIVELY SAY,
JUST BRING YOUR GATE UP TO A
CERTAIN STANDARD, AND REALLY,
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND YOU
MAY HAVE MISSED THIS IS
INSTALLING A $50 PART IF THAT
WAS INSTALLED, THE GATE WOULD
NOT HAVE FALLEN ON A CHILD AND
KILLED HIM HERE, WHAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS RIGHT NOW IS LIABILITY OF
A PUBLIC ENTITY. IF YOU'RE
NEGLIGENT AROUND A GATE OR AT
FAULT, YOU ARE GOING TO BE SUED
NOW SUCCESSFULLY. THIS DOES NOT
CHANGE LIABILITY. SO THAT EXISTS
NOW. WE HAVE TAKEN AMENDMENTS.
WHERE THROUGH 2025, THIS BILL
WILL ONLY APPLY TO SCHOOLS AND
PUBLIC PARKS THEREAFTER. IT WILL
ALSO APPLY TO NEW GATES. SO I'M
NOT SURE WHERE THE OPPOSITION
WAS COMING FROM BECAUSE WE HAVE
AGREED TO THAT. THIS WILL ONLY
APPLY TO NEW GATES, FURTHERMORE,
THERE SEEMS TO BE SOME CONFUSION
AROUND WHEN SOMETHING IS OPEN TO
THE PUBLIC. WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT A WINERY THAT HAS,
EMPLOYEES AND A COUPLE OF
OWNERS, AND THAT'S IT, IF YOU'RE
OPEN TO THE PUBLIC AND YOU HAVE
FOLKS COMING IN, MAKE YOUR GATES
SAFE, INSTALL THE $50 PART, SO
REALLY, THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE. I'M FRANKLY
SURPRISED AT THE LAST MINUTE
LEVEL OF OPPOSITION WE'VE
GOTTEN. I DO WANT TO MENTION ONE
THING SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE I
THINK IT WAS A LEGITIMATE POINT,
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS ISSUE. AND THAT IS THERE IS
A DIFFERENT, PROTOCOL, IF YOU
WILL, ON INSPECTIONS WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THEY DON'T REPORT TO
THE LOCAL BUILDING INSPECTOR, IT
WOULD BE EFFECTIVELY TO A STATE
ENTITY. SO WE'RE WILLING TO WORK
WITH THAT OPPOSITION TO FURTHER
CLARIFY HOW THAT SHOULD WORK IN
THE BILL, AND, I THINK YOU
STARTED REFERRING TO IT, A
CONSIDERABLE INTENDED TO BE USED
BY THE PUBLIC, AN ENTIRE
COMMUNITY OR NEIGHBORHOOD OR ANY
CONSIDERABLE NUMBER OF PERSONS,
THAT CONSIDERABLE NUMBER OF
PERSONS SEEMS VERY VAGUE. WELL,
AND AGAIN, THAT LANGUAGE WAS IN
RESPONSE TO THEIR ORIGINAL
OPPOSITION. SO WE'RE IF THERE'S
STILL VAGUENESS OR A BETTER WAY
OF SAYING THAT, I THINK WE ALL
KNOW WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
IF THERE'S A BETTER WAY TO SAY
IT, WE'RE ALL EARS ON THAT AS
WELL. WELL, I WOULD ASK YOU, IN
TERMS OF A CONSIDERABLE NUMBER
OF PERSONS, IS THAT LIKE ON A
ONE TIME DEAL OR IS THAT LIKE A
CONTINUOUSLY THERE'S A
CONSIDERABLE NUMBER OF PERSONS
JUST SO THAT I COULD KNOW WHAT
IT IS TO SUGGEST. YEAH I WAS
SURPRISED TO HEAR THE EXAMPLE OF
LIKE IF YOU'RE HAVING A PRIVATE
PARTY IN YOUR BACKYARD, THAT'S
NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
ADDRESS. IT REALLY IS,
FACILITIES OR SITES THAT ARE
OPEN TO THE PUBLIC, IN A
CONSIDERABLE WAY. SO IT'S ONLY
PUBLIC. OKAY. OKAY. WELL, I
STILL HAVE MORE QUESTIONS. I
HOPE THAT A LOT OF THESE GET
ADDRESSED, YOU KNOW, BETWEEN NOW
AND THE NEXT. NEXT TIME WE HAVE
TO VOTE. THANK ALL RIGHTY. THANK
YOU, SENATOR CABALLERO. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. I WE WERE
PRESENTED WITH SOME PICTURES. IS
THIS CAN YOU IS THIS, SENATOR?
SO THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF A GATE
THAT MIGHT BE ON A VINEYARD, ON
A DIRT ROAD THAT IS NOT IS
KEEPING VEHICLES OUT OF A
VINEYARD AS AN EXAMPLE, IT'S
QUITE DIFFERENT THAN, I THINK
SOME OF THE OTHER EXAMPLES GIVEN
AROUND GATES THAT PRESENT A RISK
, AND THE SO WE JUST WANT FOLKS
TO BE AWARE THAT LIKE A SINGLE
PIPE GATE WOULD BE MORE THAN 50
POUNDS AND WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THIS, AND WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
IT CREATES A SIGNIFICANT RISK TO
THE PUBLIC OR A CONSIDERABLE
NUMBER OF PERSONS. AND I ALSO,
OH, SORRY. SO THIS IS THIS IS A
GATE THAT PROBABLY HAS A SIGN
THAT SAYS DO NOT TRESPASS, NOT
OPEN TO THE PUBLIC. I'M ASSUMING
LIKELY. YES. OKAY. SO THAT IS
NOT WHAT WAS INTENDED. HOLD ON.
LET ME LET ME CLARIFY THIS
BECAUSE THIS COMES UP A LOT. SO
THAT'S CALLED A SWINGING GATE,
WHICH IT'S ON A HINGE, IT'S NOT
ACCURATE TO SAY THESE DO NOT
POSE DANGER. SO THERE'S A WELL
DOCUMENTED CASE OF A WOMAN
OUTSIDE. I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT IF IT'S INCLUDED IN
THE BILL OR NOT. SO IT IS. IT'S
A SWINGING GATE, BUT NOT IF IT'S
NOT OPEN TO THE PUBLIC. IT'S
CORRECT. BUT THAT TYPE OF GATE
DESIGN DOES POSE A DANGER. AND
THE REASON I MENTION THIS IS
THERE WAS A WOMAN IN ARCHES
NATIONAL PARK IN UTAH WHO WAS
DECAPITATED BY THAT VERY SAME
GATE DESIGN WHEN A GUST OF WIND
BLEW IT THROUGH HER CAR
WINDSHIELD. IT WAS NATIONAL NEWS
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO. AND SO
WHILE THAT GATE, WE CAN DEBATE
WHERE IT SHOULD BE APPLIED,
THERE'S TWO BASIC MECHANISMS FOR
HOW A GATE IS DESIGNED. IT
EITHER ROLLS ON WHEELS AND IT
CAN FALL OFF THE TRACK. THE
PROVERBIAL IDIOM, THE WHEELS
COME OFF THE TRACK IF IT SWINGS,
IT'S ON A HINGE. AND IF IT'S NOT
PROPERLY SECURED, THERE HAVE
BEEN EXAMPLES WHERE A GUST OF
WIND BLOWING 50 POUNDS OF METAL
RIGHT, CAN CAUSE EITHER FATALITY
OR SERIOUS INJURY. SO BOTH GATE
DESIGNS ARE INTENDED TO BE
CAPTURED. THE DEBATE IS WHERE DO
YOU CAPTURE IT TO THE COMMENT
YOU WERE MAKING OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC, ETC. RIGHT. WELL, I'M
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT AND WHERE
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT IT. AND
THE, I, I APPRECIATE THE BILL,
AND I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO WITH IT, I WANT TO
SUPPORT IT, BUT I ALSO DON'T
WANT IT TO BE SO BROAD THAT,
THAT THE ARGUMENT BECOMES WE GOT
TO PROTECT EVERYBODY FROM ANY
POSSIBILITY, AND BECAUSE THAT'S,
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE. RIGHT? IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE. WE DO THE BEST WE
CAN, THE, THE A GATE THAT WORKS
ON A MOTOR, I GET IT, IT'S OUT
OF YOUR CONTROL. ONCE IT STARTS
OPERATING. BUT BUT, I JUST THINK
THAT THAT, I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY, BUT I THINK YOU
NEED TO WORK ON SOME OF THE, THE
NARROWING IT. SO. OR LET ME PUT
IT THIS WAY, MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
WHAT KIND OF GATES YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT, AND, IF PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO TRESPASS, IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO TRY TO, IN EVERY
EVENTUALITY TO, TO PROTECT THEM.
I GET THE NEGLIGENCE TYPE OF
STUFF, BUT GROSSLY NEGLIGENT.
RIGHT. AND THAT GETS INTO ALL
THE LAW. I DON'T WANT TO GET IN
THERE, I THINK IF YOU NARROW
THIS, THIS WOULD BE A REALLY
GOOD BILL. I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
IT. YEAH. NO. AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. WE ARE TOTALLY OPEN TO
WORKING ON THAT. HOPEFULLY
THERE'S MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT.
I'LL JUST SAY THAT LANGUAGE WAS
ADDED LATER THROUGH COMMITTEE
PROCESSES. SO WE'RE OPEN TO ANY
ADDITIONAL IDEAS. I THINK WE
KNOW WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE. SO IT'S JUST SAYING IT IN
THE PROPER WAY. THAT'S I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I THANK YOU
FOR THAT. THE PICTURE AND THE
COMMENT. THANK YOU. SENATOR
CAVALLERO. OTHER QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE, ALL RIGHT
, IS THERE A MOTION SENATOR
CAVALLERO MOVES THE BILL. SENATE
MEMBER CONLEY, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? YEAH. REALLY APPRECIATE
THE ONGOING CONVERSATION. WE
HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE WORK TO
DO ON THIS BILL, BUT WITH THIS
MEASURE, WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
NO OTHER FAMILY WILL HAVE TO
FACE THIS KIND OF TRAGEDY. AND
WITH THAT, THANK YOU AGAIN. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU. YES.
THEY'VE ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS,
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FINAL ITEM 50 1AB
2149. THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG. I UMBERG
I WILK I WILK I ALLEN ASHBY.
ASHBY. I CABALLERO. CABALLERO I
DURAZO DURAZO I LAIRD. LAIRD I
NHIÀU. ROTH ROTH I STERN, STERN.
I HOPE. 8 TO 0 EIGHT ZERO. ALL
RIGHT. BILL WILL BE ON CALL.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. I SEE,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL HERE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL, ITEM 50
AB 2331. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. CHAIR. I'M PLEASED TODAY TO
PRESENT AB 2031. THIS IS A
SIMPLE CLEANUP BILL THAT WILL
PROVIDE CLARIFICATION IN
CONNECTION WITH THE PURCHASE AND
SALE OF VOLUNTARY CARBON OFFSET
CREDITS. I KNOW THAT THE HOUR IS
LATE, SO I'LL LET YOU KNOW. THIS
BILL HAS NO KNOWN OPPOSITION. IT
WAS ON CONSENT AND PRIOR
COMMITTEES. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. BEST PRESENTATION
TODAY. ALL RIGHT. SUPPORT. IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB 2331,
PLEASE APPROACH CLIFTON WILSON
ON BEHALF OF THE PACIFIC
MERCHANT SHIPPING ASSOCIATION OR
SUPPORT. IF AMENDED. SORRY.
SUPPORTIVE. AMENDED. ALL RIGHT.
GREAT. THANKS. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE.
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 2331, PLEASE APPROACH SEEING
NO ONE APPROACHING, IS THERE A
QUESTION OR COMMENTS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? SENATOR STERN
MOVES THE BILL, SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FINAL ITEM 50 AB 2331. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. BERG I BERG I
WILK AYE. WILK AYE. ALLEN.
ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. RUSSELL RUSSELL.
AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD AYE. NHIÀU.
AYE. NILA. AYE ROTH. STERN
STERN. AYE. 8 TO 0. 8 TO 0.
PLEASE LET YOUR COLLEAGUES KNOW
THIS IS HOW YOU DO IT. IT'S ON
CALL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. GOOD
LUCK, ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYANT,
YOU GET MOVED UP, YOU JUST GOT
BUMPED WAY UP. ALL RIGHT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYANT AB 3265.
MAYBE YOU DIDN'T GET BUMPED UP
AS FAR AS I THOUGHT. ANY EVENT.
SO IF THE FLOOR IS YOURS, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND COLLEAGUES.
AB 3265 IS A BILL THAT WILL BE A
CATALYST FOR SUSTAINED JOB
GROWTH BY STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS WE USE FOR RENOVATING
SOUNDSTAGES AND UPDATING
PRODUCTION FACILITIES TO
INCORPORATE THE LATEST
TECHNOLOGIES. THIS BILL WAS ON
CONSENT IN THE ASSEMBLY, BOTH IN
THE NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND ON
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. IT HAS
RECEIVED NO NØ VOTES. BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. JOINING ME TODAY
IS FORMER MAJORITY LEADER
ALBERTO TORRICO, REPRESENTING
FOX STUDIOS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE TOO ARE TO RECALL.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. WE TOO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT, OTHERS IN SUPPORT, IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB 3265,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS, MIKE WEST,
ON BEHALF OF STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE APPROACH IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 3265,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
SEEING NO ONE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS.
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATOR LAIRD, I WAS JUST GOING
TO SAY, DESPITE THE WITNESS, I
WOULD MOVE THE BILL. WELL, THANK
YOU, I, I FEEL YOU SO YES, I GOT
IT. ALL RIGHT, SENATOR LAIRD HAS
MOVED THE BILL, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. YOU AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL IN COMPETITION. WE'D
LIKE TO SEE THAT ALL RIGHT,
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM 56, AB
3265. THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG Ã
UMBERG. AYE. WILK AYE. WILK AYE.
ALLEN ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE.
RUSSELL QUÊ. RUSSELL. AYE.
LAIRD. LAIRD AYE. NHIÀU. NHIÀU.
AYE ROTH. STERN STERN. AYE.
WAHAB. 8 TO 0 O. ROTH. AYE. 9 TO
0. LET'S ROTH. AYE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. 9 TO 0 NINE
ZERO, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA,
YOU HAVE BEEN HANGING OUT HERE
ALL DAY, SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
, MR. CHAIR. AND SENATORS, FILE
NUMBER 64, AB 1840. THE SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF HOME
OWNERSHIP SHOULD BE ACCESSIBLE
TO EVERYONE, REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1840 ENSURES THAT
ELIGIBILITY IN THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM FOR ALL PROGRAM INCLUDES
UNDOCUMENTED PERSONS.
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
HOUSING INITIATIVES BECAUSE OF
FEDERAL RESTRICTIONS AT THE
STATE LEVEL, LEGAL STATUS CAN
COMPLICATE ACCESS TO HOME LOANS
AND TO HOME OWNERSHIP ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS, POSING A SIGNIFICANT
HARDSHIP IN AN ALREADY
CHALLENGING SECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. ENSURING
UNIVERSAL ACCESS BY ALL
QUALIFIED BORROWERS TO THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM FOR ALL PROGRAM
WILL CONTRIBUTE TO THE OVERALL
SUCCESS AND VITALITY OF
CALIFORNIA. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL 1840 IS
BARBARA ESTELLA ORELLANO, THE
NÓI Ã CHIRLA MEMBER FROM SAN
BERNARDINO, AND CYNTHIA GOMEZ,
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF STATE POLICY
AND ADVOCACY AT CHIRLA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. GOOD EVENING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I WILL BE DOING HER
TESTIMONY IN SPANISH. I'LL BE
QUICKLY TRANSLATING. I'LL BEGIN
WITH MINE. GOOD EVENING, CHAIR
AND SENATORS. MY NAME IS CYNTHIA
GOMEZ, DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF STATE
POLICY AND ADVOCACY WITH THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS. CHIRLA CHIRLA IS PROUD
TO SPONSOR AB 1840 AND ARE
THANKFUL FOR THE LEADERSHIP OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA ON THIS
BILL. IN 2021, CALIFORNIA
ESTABLISHED A DREAM FOR ALL
PROGRAM, WHICH IS TAILORED TO
HELP LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
FIRST TIME HOMEBUYERS PURCHASE A
HOME SPECIFICALLY PROVIDING A
SHARED APPRECIATION LOAN TO HELP
COVER THE COST OF A DOWN
PAYMENT. THIS WAS A SIGNIFICANT
STEP TOWARDS HELPING FIRST TIME
HOME BUYERS, AS MANY FIND THAT
COVERING THE COST OF A DOWN
PAYMENT TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
HURDLE IN THEIR ASPIRATIONS TO
PURCHASE A HOME. HOME OWNERSHIP
IS A CORNERSTONE OF GENERATIONAL
WEALTH, AND HISTORIC POLICIES
ROOTED IN RACIAL BIAS HAVE
RESULTED IN LOWER HOME OWNERSHIP
RATES AMONG COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. AS WE WORK TO INCREASE
HOME OWNERSHIP IN CALIFORNIA, WE
MUST ENSURE THAT LAWS THE LAWS
THAT WE ENACT, ARE INCLUSIVE AND
ACCESSIBLE TO UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS WHO CALL CALIFORNIA
HOME, WHICH IS PRECISELY WHAT AB
1840 SEEKS TO ACHIEVE. AB 1840
WOULD ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUAL IS
NOT TURNED AWAY FROM THE DREAM
FOR ALL PROGRAM SOLELY BASED ON
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS.
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS ARE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTORS TO OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY, CONTRIBUTING
ROUGHLY $51 BILLION IN STATE AND
LOCAL TAXES. THESE CONTRIBUTIONS
HELP FUND THE VARIOUS STATE AND
LOCAL PROGRAMS. HOWEVER, BECAUSE
OF THEIR DOCUMENTATION STATUS,
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS ARE
UNABLE TO BENEFIT FROM THE VERY
PROGRAMS THAT THEY HELP FUND. AB
1840 ALIGNS WITH OUR GOALS AS A
STATE WHERE ALL CALIFORNIANS,
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS, CAN ACCESS CRITICAL
PROGRAMS. WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION ON THIS BILL AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS, PLEASE. BUENAS
TARDES. ME NUMBER ORELLANA SOY,
ORIGINALLY OF EL SALVADOR.
CONFORME UNA FAMILIA DE TRES ME
FAMILIA. YO TUVIMOS C¯ MIGRAR DE
NUESTRO PAIS POR LA ZONA DE
SEGURIDAD Y CON MILLAS Y COMO SI
MILHARES DE FAMILIAS VENIMOS A
ESTADOS UNIDOS BUSCANDO UNA
MEJOR CALIDAD DE VIDA. PODEMOS
PODER NO DESARROLLAR COMO
FAMILIA Y CUMPLIR NUESTROS
SUENOS. ACTUALMENTE VIVIMOS EN
LA CIUDAD DE SAN BERNARDINO,
CALIFORNIA. RENTA APARTAMENTO
PEQUENO DE DOS HABITACIONES.
AHORA MISMO LARA ACTO HEROICO
WAS TENEMOS C¯ LARA PARA CUBRIR
GASTOS DEL ANO SÐNG AUMENTADOS
IS A VUELTO MUCHO MAS CARO EL
MODO DE VIDA IN GENERAL. SOMOS
PARTE DE LA FUERZA LABORAL DE
ESTE PAIS Y COMO TODAS LAS
FAMILIAS ALEJO'S HACER REALIDAD.
NUESTRO SUENO DE TENER UNA
VIVIENDA DIGNA. LA CANADA REAL
STABILITY SENTIRNOS EN UN TECHO
SEGURO Â C¯ EN UN FUTURO ESTÁ
SE CONVIERTE EN NUESTRO
PATRIMONIO FAMILIA. IN NOVEMBER
23, ESTAMOS CON UNA FINANCIERA
PARA TENER UN CRÉDITO
HIPOTECARIO POR PRIMERA VEZ.
DESAFORTUNADAMENTE NO PODEMOS
CALIFICAR PORQUE AL SOLO CONTAR
CON UN NUMERO DE TÍNH LA
FINANCIERA NO EXPLICO
NECESITARIA MAS CUMPLIR MÀ
REQUISITOS COMO ES AUMENTAR A
DOWN PAYMENT. ESTA BIEN DE POR
CIENTO DE VALOR DE LA PROPIEDAD
Y CONTAR CON UN COSIGNER
KAYSERISPOR PARA RESPALDAR
NUESTRO CRÉDITO, CON LO CUAL NO
CONTAMOS. EL DIA DE HOY VENGO A
LES QUÊ A FAVOR DE LA PROPUESTA
DE SOTO CUENTA ESTE PROYECTO DE
LEY ESTATAL BENEFICIARY A MUCHAS
FAMILIAS COMO LA MIA PARA PODER,
CREAR UNA PROPIEDAD Y AL MISMO
TIEMPO CONTRIBUIR A AUN MAS A LA
ECONOMIA DE CALIFORNIA. LES PIDO
NÓ LO VAN COMO UN GUSTO VERLO
COMO UNA INVERSION A FUTURO
BENEFICIARY A NUESTRO ESTADO.
MUCHAS GRACIAS POR SU TIEMPO.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
ORIANA. I'M ORIGINALLY FROM EL
SALVADOR. I HAVE A FAMILY OF
THREE. MY FAMILY AND I HAD TO
MIGRATE FROM OUR COUNTRY FOR
SECURITY REASONS. AND LIKE,
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES, WE CAME TO THE UNITED
STATES LOOKING FOR A BETTER WAY
OF LIFE, TO BE ABLE TO GROW AS A
FAMILY AND TO FULFILL OUR
DREAMS. WE CURRENTLY LIVE IN THE
CITY OF SAN BERNARDINO, WHERE WE
RENT A SMALL TWO BEDROOM
APARTMENT. RIGHT NOW, SAVING
BECOMES A HEROIC ACT SINCE WE
HAVE TO ADJUST OUR SAVINGS TO
COVER RENTAL EXPENSES THAT
INCREASE EVERY YEAR, AND THE WAY
OF LIFE IN GENERAL HAS BECOME
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE. WE ARE PART
OF THE WORK FORCE OF THIS
COUNTRY, AND LIKE ALL FAMILIES,
WE LONG TO MAKE OUR DREAM OF
HAVING A HOME COME TRUE, WHICH
WOULD GIVE US A STABILITY AND
WOULD BECOME OUR OUR FAMILY
INHERITANCE IN THE FUTURE. IN
NOVEMBER 2023, WE MET WITH A
FINANCIAL COMPANY TO OBTAIN A
MORTGAGE LOAN FOR THE FIRST
TIME. UNFORTUNATELY, WE COULD
NOT QUALIFY BECAUSE SINCE WE
ONLY HAVE ITIN NUMBERS, THE
FINANCIAL COMPANY EXPLAINED THAT
WE'D HAVE TO MEET MORE
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS INCREASING
THE DOWN PAYMENT UP TO 20% OF
THE VALUE OF THE PROPERTY, AND
HAVE A COSIGNER, WHICH WE DID
NOT HAVE. TODAY, I COME TO ASK
YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF AB 1840,
WHICH WOULD HELP MANY FAMILIES
LIKE MINE BE ABLE TO ACQUIRE A
HOME AND AT THE SAME TIME
CONTRIBUTE EVEN MORE TO THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. I ASK YOU
DON'T VIEW THIS AS AN EXPENSE
FOR THE STATE, BUT RATHER AS AN
INVESTMENT THAT WOULD BENEFIT
OUR STATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. ALRIGHTY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OF AB 1840, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. NOW
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
MIREYA SUAREZ, COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER WITH CHIRLA. AND I'M
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IRMA
JEANETTE ESCOBAR WITH CHIRLA. I
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LARA TO THE
CHIRLA. I SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
BECCA KRAMER, ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NHIÀU TH¤U ON BEHALF
OF THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
CATHERINE CHARLES, ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE. LET'S
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 1840,
PLEASE COME FORWARD SEEING NO
ONE COMING FORWARD, LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING ONE
SENATOR LAIR, THEN SENATOR
CABALLERO. OH, ACTUALLY, SHE
STOLE MY THUNDER BECAUSE I WAS
GOING TO SAY IF I WASN'T GOING
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL ALREADY,
THE FACT THAT HE SAT THERE FOR
HALF HIS NATURAL LIFE DURING
THIS HEARING AND NEVER GOT
CALLED TO COME UP HERE, WOULD
HAVE MOTIVATED ME TO SUPPORT IT
AS WELL. SO ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU
. PERSISTENCE PAYS OFF. ALL
RIGHT. SENATOR CABALLERO, I JUST
WANTED TO SHOW MY APPRECIATION
TO THE AUTHOR FOR, FOR THIS
BILL. THIS IS REALLY AN
IMPORTANT AND REALLY INCREDIBLY,
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE DIDN'T
THINK ABOUT THIS SOONER. WE
PROBABLY SHOULD GO THROUGH AND
LOOK AT ALL THE DIFFERENT,
CATEGORIES WHERE WE CAN SAY
SPECIFICALLY THAT WE WANT TO
INCLUDE UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS,
AND, AND, AND DO IT BECAUSE IT'S
THE RIGHT THING TO DO. SO I SAID
THAT LAS GRACIAS A TODOS LAS
PERSONAS QUÊ VINIERON AQUI HOY
EN TODO EL DIA AQUI ESPERANDO
PARA PODER DA SU TESTIMONIO.
MUCHAS GRACIAS. NOW I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. WHAT? SHE SAID
OKAY. OTHERS OTHERS WHO WISH TO.
ALL RIGHT. IS THERE A MOTION?
SENATOR DURAZZO MOVES THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT. LIKE SO MANY
IMMIGRANTS, I, TOO, HAD THE
GANAS TODAY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
GOT THIS BILL ACROSS. AND FOR SO
MANY IMMIGRANTS, IT'S THE
OPPORTUNITY TOWARDS GENERATIONAL
WEALTH. THAT HOME OWNERSHIP
AVAILS YOURSELF TO. THAT IS THE
PROMISE THAT THIS BILL HAS. AND
I'M EXCITED THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
BE ABLE TO PRESENT THIS BILL
TODAY AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY, IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DURAZZO. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM 64, AB
1840. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
UMBERG A UMBERG I WILK NÓ WILK
NÓ ALLEN. ASHBY. ASHBY I.
CABALLERO CABALLERO I DURAZZO.
DURAZZO I. LAIRD A. LAIRD I.
NILO. NILO. NÓ. ROTH A. ROTH I
STERN, A STERN I. WAHAB 7 TO 2.
7 TO 2. THAT BILL WILL BE ON
CALL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN. I'M SO IMPRESSED
THAT IT IS 530 AND YOU'RE ON
EASE. I'M QUITE IMPRESSED. YOU
CAN THANK SENATOR WILK. I THINK
SO, VICE CHAIR. WELL, AND I JUST
FIND IT. I MEAN, YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT IT WAS, SENATOR
UMBERG THAT STARTED AT THE Z
ALONG WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS. SO OTHERWISE WE WOULD
HAVE STARTED WITH THE AYES, AND
YOU WOULD HAVE BEEN UP A LOT
SOONER. I KNOW SENATOR CABALLERO
WOULD HAVE APPROVED OF THE
BEGINNING OF THE ALPHABET. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE AWARE,
SENATOR CABALLERO, BUT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS IS CHAIR OF
APPROPRIATIONS IN THE ASSEMBLY.
ARE YOU AWARE OF THAT? ALL
RIGHT. OKAY ALL RIGHT. SO, ALL
RIGHT, SO, AB 1008, FILE NUMBER
61. DO YOU MIND IF WE START WITH
1836? BECAUSE MY WITNESS. THAT'S
FINE. GREAT NUMBER 62. ÁP 1836.
SORRY TO JUMP AROUND ON ALL OF
YOU, BUT PERFECT. THANK YOU, I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF. AND BEFORE I START,
ACTUALLY, I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
IMMENSE GRATITUDE FOR THIS
COMMITTEE, BOTH THE CHAIR, BUT
ALSO PARTICULARLY CHRISTIAN, WHO
I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING WITH ON ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE BILLS, NOT JUST MY
OWN, AND IT'S BEEN INCREDIBLE.
YOU HAVE INCREDIBLE STAFF HERE,
AND IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO WORK
WITH YOU. SO I WANT TO START
WITH THAT. BUT, AND I'LL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS ON THIS
BILL. SO WITH THAT, I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AB 1836. CALIFORNIA, AS
WE ALL KNOW, IS A HUB FOR
ARTISTS AND ARTISTIC EXPRESSION.
PERFORMERS AND CELEBRITIES BUILD
THEIR CAREERS BASED ON THEIR
SIGNATURE PERFORMANCES. OUR
STATE HAS AN EXCEPTIONALLY
STRONG PROTECTION FOR LIVING
ARTISTS AGAINST THE EXPLOITATION
OF THEIR LIKENESS, BUT THAT
PROTECTION IS NOT EXTENDED TO
DECEASED PERFORMERS. UNDER
CURRENT LAW, IMAGES AND VIDEOS
OF DECEASED PERFORMERS ARE
ALLOWED TO BE USED IN A BROAD
RANGE OF CREATIVE WORKS,
INCLUDING AN EXPLICIT EXEMPTION
FOR AUDIOVISUAL WORKS BEFORE THE
ADVENT OF AI. AS WE KNOW IT
TODAY. THIS MAY HAVE NOT BEEN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT, BUT NOW WE
KNOW THAT DECEASED PERFORMERS
CAN BE EXPLOITED IN NEW WAYS. AI
REPLICAS OF PERFORMERS ALLOW A
FULL REANIMATION, CREATING WORK
IN THE IMAGE AND LIKENESS OF THE
DECEASED PERFORMER THAT THEIR
ESTATE HAS NO SAY IN AND MAY
RECEIVE NO COMPENSATION FOR. AND
I'LL SAY IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT,
NOT JUST THE COMPENSATION, BUT
WE HEARD FROM ONE NOTABLE
DECEASED ACTOR'S FAMILY WHERE
THAT ACTOR HAD PUT INTO HIS WILL
THAT HE DIDN'T WANT HIS LIKENESS
TO BE USED AFTER HIS DEATH, AND
HE SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO
CONTROL THAT, THIS BILL ALLOWS
DECEASED PERFORMERS THE RIGHT TO
NOT BE REANIMATED WITHOUT THE
CONSENT OF THEIR WILL OR ESTATE.
BY RESTRICTING THIS TO
CONVINCING DIGITAL REPLICAS, THE
BILL PROTECTS AGAINST FUTURE
ABUSES WITHOUT ALTERING THE
EXEMPTIONS FOR HIRING ACTORS OR
USING PREVIOUSLY WORKS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY LEGAL. WITH ME IN
SUPPORT IS DOUG MORRELL,
ATTORNEY WITH SAG-AFTRA AND
ACTRESS JODI LONG. GOOD EVENING.
MY NAME IS JODI LONG, AND I'M AN
ACTOR, AND SAG-AFTRA LOS ANGELES
LOCAL PRESIDENT REPRESENTING MY
COLLEAGUES WHO RELY ON OUR FACES
AND VOICES TO SUPPORT OUR
LIVELIHOODS AND OUR FAMILIES.
NONE OF US WANT TO BECOME
DIGITIZED REPLICAS OF OURSELVES
AFTER WE DIE, SUBJECT TO THE
WILL OF THOSE WHO NOT ONLY CAN
MANIPULATE OUR IMAGES AND VOICES
, BUT POTENTIALLY USE THEM TO
SELL PRODUCTS, WE DON'T BELIEVE
IN OR SERVE AGENDAS. WE BE
OPPOSED TO LONG AFTER WE ARE
DEAD. TO EXPLAIN WHY AB 1836 IS
SO IMPORTANT, I'LL SHARE MY
STORY. IN THE BEGINNING OF 2020,
I WAS SHOOTING A FILM IN
AUSTRALIA. THE FIRST DAY I WENT
THROUGH MY CUSTOMARY HAIR AND
MAKEUP TESTS AND COSTUME
FITTINGS. THEN I WAS TOLD I
NEEDED TO GET SCANNED, WHICH
ENTAILED GOING INTO A CAGE
FILLED WITH HUNDREDS OF CAMERAS
THAT WOULD TAKE A PICTURE OF
EVERY INCH OF MY BODY. I WAS
NEVER INFORMED OF THIS, AND MY
AGENTS WERE HALFWAY AROUND THE
WORLD ASLEEP AT THAT TIME, THERE
WAS NO LANGUAGE WRITTEN INTO OUR
CONTRACTS REGARDING SCANNING.
MANY TIMES I THOUGHT TO MYSELF,
WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY USE MY
DIGITAL SCAN FOR A PREQUEL OR A
SEQUEL AND I'M DEAD? GETTING
THOSE GUIDELINES AROUND ACTORS
DIGITAL REPLICAS BECAME A MAJOR
TOPIC DURING OUR 2023 CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS, AND A KEY FACTOR
IN OUR STRIKE AGAINST THE
STUDIOS AND STREAMERS. WELL, I'M
HAPPY TO SAY THAT SAG-AFTRA WAS
FINALLY ABLE TO GET THE FIRST
CONTRACTUAL AI PROTECTIONS IN
THIS AREA FOR OUR MEMBERS, YET
CURRENTLY, THERE ARE NO
LEGISLATIVE GUARDRAILS FOR
EVERYONE ELSE, INCLUDING HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS, ATHLETES, AND
LAWMAKERS LIKE YOURSELF.
SENATORS, IMAGINE YOU, YOUR
CHILD OR LOVED ONE WAS USED FOR
IMPROPER PURPOSES OR MANIPULATED
TO PROMOTE A HARMFUL PRODUCT OR
POLITICAL AGENDA. THEY DIDN'T
BELIEVE IN. THAT'S A REALITY
MADE POSSIBLE WITH UNCHECKED USE
OF THIS TECHNOLOGY. PROTECTIONS
NEED TO EXIST FOR THE DECEASED
AND THEIR FAMILIES. AFTER ALL,
IF WE'RE INDEED A FREE COUNTRY,
THEN WE SHOULD BE FREE TO LIVE
AND DIE WITHOUT THE FEAR OF
BECOMING SOMEONE ELSE'S UNPAID
DIGITAL PUPPET. FOR THESE
REASONS, I STRONGLY URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO VOTE YES ON AB
1836. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU, HONORABLE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS DOUG
MORRELL AND I'M A PARTNER IN THE
LOS ANGELES LAW FIRM OF
GREENBERG GLUSKER I APPEAR IN
SUPPORT OF AB 1836, MY PRIMARY
INTEREST LIES IN ENSURING THAT
CONSENT REMAINS THE FUNDAMENTAL
TOUCHSTONE WHEN IT COMES TO
DECIDING WHETHER, AND, IF SO,
HOW TO PERMIT GENERATIVE,
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
TECHNOLOGY TO BE USED TO
DIGITALLY REANIMATE DECEASED
PERFORMERS. I APPLAUD THE
COMMITTEE'S EXCELLENT AND
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS OF AB
1836, AND AS I UNDERSTAND IT,
THE ONLY LINGERING CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS LEGISLATION AS
EXPRESSED BY THE MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION AND THE STUDIOS IT
REPRESENTS, HAVE BEEN FULLY
ADDRESSED BY ADOPTING THE
LANGUAGE OF THE REWORKED
EXEMPTION FOUND AT THE TOP OF
PAGE TEN OF THE ANALYSIS. THUS
THE BASIS FOR THE ONLY REMAINING
OPPOSITION OF RECORD BOILS DOWN
TO AN AVERSION TO THE VERY
EXISTENCE OF THE POSTMORTEM
RIGHT OF PUBLICITY. BUT THAT
ISSUE I RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT, WAS
LAID TO REST NEARLY 40 YEARS
AGO, WHEN THIS LEGISLATURE
ADOPTED A STATE STATUTORY
POSTMORTEM RIGHT OF PUBLICITY.
AND NOW CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF 27
STATES TO RECOGNIZE SUCH A
RIGHT, WHETHER BY STATUTE AND OR
AT COMMON LAW. IT'S WORTH NOTING
THAT NOTHING IN AB 1836 WOULD
REQUIRE MOTION PICTURE PRODUCERS
OR STUDIOS TO DO ANYTHING OTHER
THAN WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN DOING.
THERE ARE AT LEAST FIVE
INSTANCES IN THE LAST QUARTER
CENTURY WHERE PERMISSION TO USE
THE VOICE AND OR LIKENESS OF
DECEASED PERFORMERS HAS BEEN
SOUGHT AND OBTAINED FROM THE
FAMILIES OR OTHER
REPRESENTATIVES OF THEIR
RESPECTIVE ESTATES, AND THIS
BILL SIMPLY ENSURES THAT SUCH
CONSENT WILL CONTINUE TO BE
REQUIRED WHEN AI VERSIONS OF
RECOGNIZABLE DECEASED PERFORMERS
ARE BEING USED. FINALLY, THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE LAW TOO OFTEN
LAGS BEHIND THE ADVANCEMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY. FORTUNATELY, AB 1836
ANTICIPATES AND ENSURES THE
RIGHT OF SURVIVING FAMILIES AND
OTHER REPRESENTATIVES TO CONSENT
OR REFUSE TO CONSENT TO AI
MANIPULATIONS OF THEIR LOVED
ONES. I URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU, MR. MORELLE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT, THOSE IN SUPPORT OF AB,
1836, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
FELIPE FUENTES HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE MOTION PICTURE ASSOCIATION
AND FIRST OF ALL, WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND HER SPONSORS FOR
ALL OF THE WORK THAT'S GONE INTO
THIS MEASURE. AND MR. MORELLE
HIT IT RIGHT ON THE HEAD. WITH
ALL OF THAT WORK, WE ARE ABLE TO
GET INTO A NEUTRAL POSITION. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND TO YOUR
STAFF, OF COURSE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. OTHERS IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE, LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 1836, PLEASE APPROACH. NOT
WHO I WAS EXPECTING. GO AHEAD.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. GOOD
EVENING, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS LIZZIE KUTSUNAI. I'M
WITH CHAU YODER AND SCHMELZER
AND L®NG. AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF MY CLIENT, TECHNET AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB
1836. WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
CHANGES SUGGESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE AND AGREED BY THE
AUTHOR. WE SHARED MANY OF THE
CONCERNS THAT HAD PREVIOUSLY
PREVIOUSLY BEEN RAISED BY THE
MOTION PICTURE ASSOCIATION, AND
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR ADDRESSING
THOSE WITH AMENDMENTS. HOWEVER,
WE WANT TO OFFER A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE ON THE
REMAINING LANGUAGE AND HAVE A
SUGGESTED CHANGE TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERN. AS NOTED, AB 1836 WOULD
MAKE ANY PERSON WHO PRODUCES,
DISTRIBUTES OR MAKES AVAILABLE
THE DIGITAL REPLICA OF A
DECEASED PERSONALITY'S LIKENESS
LIABLE FOR DAMAGES. BECAUSE THIS
LIABILITY EXTENDS TO ANY PERSON
THAT PRODUCES, DISTRIBUTES, OR
MAKES AVAILABLE SUCH A DIGITAL
REPLICA, IT IS UNCLEAR IF THE
DEPLOYERS OF AI SYSTEMS MORE
BROADLY COULD BE HELD LIABLE IF
A USER CHOOSES TO USE SUCH A
SYSTEM TO CREATE AND DISSEMINATE
CONTENT WITHOUT AUTHORIZATION
FROM THE DEPICTED INDIVIDUAL.
NOT ALL DIGITAL SERVICES HAVE
KNOWLEDGE OF EVERY NUANCE FOR
SPECIFIC PIECES OF CONTENT
HOSTED ON THEIR PLATFORMS.
HOWEVER, UNDER CURRENT LANGUAGE,
A WEBSITE, ONLINE PLATFORM, OR
EVEN A DEVICE MANUFACTURER COULD
STILL BE HELD LIABLE. WE
RECOMMEND THAT LIABILITY BE
TARGETED TO A PERSON OR ENTITY
WHO INTENTIONALLY OR KNOWINGLY
COMMITTED DECEPTIVE ACTS USING A
DIGITAL REPLICA, RATHER THAN
TYING LIABILITY TO A PRODUCT
THAT ALLOWED THE MEDIA TO BE
GENERATED OR SERVED AS MEANS FOR
IT TO BE SHARED. WE SUGGEST
CLARIFYING THIS ISSUE BY
INCLUDING A KNOWLEDGE STANDARD
SUCH THAT LIABILITY APPLIES TO A
PERSON WHO KNOWINGLY DISTRIBUTES
A DECEASED PERSONALITY'S
LIKENESS, WITH THE KNOWLEDGE
THAT THEY DID NOT CONSENT TO THE
USE. WE SUGGEST DEFINING
KNOWLEDGE AS ACTUAL OR
CONSTRUCTIVE KNOWLEDGE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE TO RESOLVE THIS ISSUE,
AND FOR THESE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU
VIÆT. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION, MR. CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS, OPPOSITION IS SUCH A
STRONG WORD, ISN'T IT, WE'RE I
REPRESENT JUST WHEN WE THOUGHT
WE HAD PEACE IN OUR TIME. GO
AHEAD. YES I REPRESENT THE
RECORDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OF AMERICA, AND WE HAVE BEEN
CONCEPTUALLY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
BILL THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS.
THIS RECENT AMENDMENT ACTUALLY
GIVES US HEARTBURN AND CONCERN.
I WANT TO EXPLAIN WHY,
SPECIFICALLY THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED TO REMOVE THE PHRASE TO
THE EXTENT THE USE IS PROTECTED
BY THE FIRST AMENDMENT TO THE US
CONSTITUTION. FROM THE LIST OF
EXEMPTIONS PROPOSED. IF THE
EXEMPTIONS STAND WITH NO
QUALIFICATIONS, THEN THE
EXEMPTIONS EXEMPT USE OF AI THAT
MOVE FAR BEYOND EXPRESSION THAT
IS PROTECTED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. WE BELIEVE THIS WOULD
LEAD TO HARMFUL RESULTS AND
FUNCTIONALLY OVERTURN SETTLED
FIRST AMENDMENT PRECEDENT FOR
EXAMPLE, A CATEGORICAL EXEMPTION
TO RIGHTS OF PUBLICITY FOR ANY
NEWS, PUBLIC AFFAIRS OR SPORTS
BROADCAST WOULD OVERTURN THE
PRECEDENT REFERENCED IN YOUR
ANALYSIS, WHERE THE COURT HELD
THAT THE FIRST AMENDMENT DID NOT
PROTECT A NEWS OUTLET FROM A
RIGHT OF PUBLICITY SUIT FOR
BROADCASTING A PERFORMER'S ACT
IN ITS ENTIRETY, AND THEREFORE
HARMING THE PERFORMER'S WORK OR
THE MARKET FOR THEIR WORK.
MOREOVER, A CATEGORICAL
STATUTORY EXEMPTION FOR SATIRE
OR PARODY COULD PERMIT THE USE
OF AN AI GENERATED ELVIS OR
FRANK SINATRA IN A DEEPLY
OFFENSIVE OR SEXUALLY EXPLICIT
PARODY OF A PAST PERFORMANCE
THAT CROSSES THE LINE INTO
MATERIAL THE CONSTITUTION DOES
NOT PROTECT. WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT. WE'VE GIVEN THE
COMMITTEE, YOUR STAFF, A
PROPOSED AMENDMENT TO FIX THAT.
WE'VE GIVEN IT THE AUTHOR AS
WELL. WE'LL CERTAINLY TRY TO
WORK ON THAT OVER THE SUMMER, IF
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DESTINED TO
DO. THE OTHER THING I WOULD
RAISE IS WE PROVIDED THE AUTHOR
SEVERAL TIMES A PROVISION THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE RECORD COMPANIES
TO STAND IN FOR THE ARTIST'S
HEIRS WHEN WE HAVE TO PURSUE AN
ACTION NOBODY'S DISAGREED WITH
THAT. WE JUST HAVEN'T PUT IT
INTO THE BILL YET, THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PROTECTION, BECAUSE
TYPICALLY THE HEIRS DON'T WANT
TO BE IN COURT SUING PEOPLE.
THEY LET THE COMPANY DO THAT FOR
THEM. AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IN THE BILL AS
WELL. SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
WE'RE SORT OF CONCERNED. NOW, I
WOULDN'T OPPOSE, AGAIN, AS A
STRONG WORD, BUT WE'RE, WE'D
LIKE TO RESOLVE SOME OF THESE
THINGS AS WE MOVE FORWARD. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN KIND, OPPOSITION OR
EVEN OPPOSITION. SO WE'RE
PRESENTING THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
. GOOD EVENING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. NAOMI PETRONE, ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPUTER AND
COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE WOULD ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS MADE WITH TECHNET.
THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING.
ROANOKE. ALONG WITH CAL CHAMBER,
WE ALSO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
TECHNET. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
QUESTIONS BY SEEING NO
QUESTIONS, NO COMMENTS. IS THERE
A MOTION? MR. STERN'S MAKING A
MOTION, SENATOR, MAKE A MOTION
WITH A BRIEF COMMENT, WITH
GRATITUDE TO MISS WONG FROM ONE
OF YOUR MEMBERS, WHO HAPPENS TO
BE MY DAD. AND HE SAID, DON'T
DON'T GO ALTER HIS SCHNOZ IN A
FUTURE HOME ALONE 14 AND THEN
WILL BE GOOD. SO I SAID, THE
BILL WILL ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN
AND THEN WE'RE ALL SET. SO I DO
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS, THOUGH.
OUTSTANDING. THANK YOU. I JUST
WANT TO SAY MY LAST NAME IS
LONG, NOT WONG. OKAY. THANK YOU,
MISS LONG. WELL, I'LL RELAY THAT
BACK AND TAKE A BEATING WHEN I
GET HOME. ALL RIGHT. BUT I'LL
TAKE HIS RECOMMENDATION UNDER
CONSIDERATION TO HEART. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. SENATOR STERN.
YOU MADE A MOTION. ALL RIGHT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU. YOU MAKE ONE GROUP HAPPY
AND ANOTHER ONE POPS UP. BUT WE
ARE WORKING INCREDIBLY HARD TO
TRY TO FIND A HAPPY PLACE IN
THIS BILL THAT WILL SATISFY
EVERYONE. AND PROTECT THE
IMPORTANT RIGHTS THAT ARE,
ACTORS AND ARTISTS IN CALIFORNIA
DESERVE. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. YES, THOSE 16 WORDS
WERE CHALLENGING EVEN FOR ME TO
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY HOW A JURY OR
A FINDER OF FACT WOULD WOULD USE
THOSE WORDS. SO WITH THAT,
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION. MADAM
CHIEF COUNSEL, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM 62 AB
1836. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE. SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
BERG BERG I WILK I WILK. AYE.
ALLEN. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE
DURAZZO. RUSSELL. AYE. LAIRD
LAIRD. AYE. MILO. NEAL. AYE
ROTH. ROTH. AYE. STERN. STERN
AYE. WAHAB 9 TO 0. MEMBERS
MISSING. NINE ZERO. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL NEXT
BILL, 61 FILE, 61 AB 1008.
PERFECT. YES. THANK YOU. SO MUCH
FOR YOUR INDULGENCE, MR. CHAIR,
THANK YOU, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, I
WANT TO START BY THANKING
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
DILIGENT WORK ON THE BILL, AND
I'LL BE ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY, SO I WILL NOT
BE COMMENTING ON THE PART OF THE
BILL THAT IS NOW NO LONGER IN
THE BILL. SO WE'LL WE'LL FOCUS
ON WHAT IT DOES AFTER THE
AMENDMENTS, SO AFTER THE
AMENDMENTS, THE BILL CLARIFIES
THAT PERSONAL INFORMATION UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY
ACT PROVIDES THAT PERSONAL
INFORMATION CAN EXIST IN A
VARIETY OF FORMATS. THIS
INCLUDES PHYSICAL FORMATS LIKE
PAPER, DOCUMENTS OR PRINTED
IMAGES, DIGITAL FORMATS LIKE
EXCEL SPREADSHEETS AND MP4
FILES, AND ABSTRACT DIGITAL
FORMATS INCLUDING AI SYSTEMS
THAT ARE CAPABLE OF OUTPUTTING
PERSONAL INFORMATION AND THAT
LAST PIECE, THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE SHOULD CLARIFY.
HOPEFULLY SOME OF THE CONCERNS
OF THE OPPOSITION WITH THE WAY
WE WERE TRYING TO TALK ABOUT AI
AND THE CCPA LIMITS A BUSINESS'S
ABILITY TO SELL PERSONAL
INFORMATION. IT IS AGNOSTIC TO
THE FORM THAT INFORMATION TAKES
WHEN IT IS TRANSFERRED BETWEEN
THE BUYER AND THE SELLER. IN
RECENT YEARS, A NEW METHOD FOR
TRANSMITTING PERSONAL
INFORMATION HAS BEEN DEVELOPED,
WE KNOW THAT OUR DATA IS NOW
BECOMING VALUABLE TO TRAIN THESE
AI SYSTEMS. IT IS THE WAY OUR
DATA IS MOST VALUABLE TODAY,
PERHAPS, AND SO WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS IT MERELY EXTENDS THOSE
PROTECTIONS THAT ALL OF US HAVE
BEEN ENJOYING FOR MANY YEARS TO
THE SALE OF OUR DATA FOR THE
TRAINING OF AI, IF THE AI MODEL
CAN OUTPUT THAT DATA, AND I
THINK IT'S ACTUALLY AN IMPORTANT
POINT TO UNDERSTAND ABOUT THESE
AI MODELS AND THE WAY THEY WORK
IS, IF YOU CAN PUT MY ADDRESS
INTO AN AI MODEL AND TRAIN IT,
IT CAN COME OUT OF THE AI MODEL
IN MANY CASES. AND SO WHAT WE
WANT TO DO IS ENSURE THAT THAT
DATA YOU BELIEVE IS PROTECTED ON
THE INTERNET IS SO IN THESE
MODELS, AS WELL, SO THAT'S THE
BILL. IT IS NOW VERY SIMPLE. SO
I ASK FOR I VOTE FIRST WITNESS.
WE DON'T HAVE A WITNESS. DON'T
HAVE A WITNESS. ALL RIGHT. THOSE
IN SUPPORT OF AB 1008 PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE SEEING
NO ONE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
MY GUESS IS WE'RE GOING TO SEE
SOME OTHERS HERE. THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 1008. PLEASE
APPROACH. THANK YOU. MEMBERS.
ROANOKE DAYLAMI WITH CAL
CHAMBER. RESPECTFULLY, WE ARE IN
AN OPPOSED POSITION TO 1008,
PRIMARILY DUE TO THE WAY THAT
THE BILL WOULD HAVE NARROWED THE
DEFINITION OF PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION. I'M NOT. IT'S BEEN
A LONG DAY. I USED TO BE ON THAT
SIDE AS A COMMITTEE CONSULTANT.
I'M NOT GOING TO CONTINUE WITH
THIS. I'M JUST GOING TO SAY THAT
WE ARE LOOKING AT THE BILL,
PARTICULARLY FOR THE PROVISIONS
THAT REMAIN AND THE AMENDMENT TO
THAT, AND WE WILL HOPEFULLY BE
ABLE TO UPDATE THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE WHERE WE ARE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. OH, HERE
WE GO, MARGARET GLADSTEIN,
EPILEPSY, ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION, WE ARE,
IN OPPOSITION NOW. WE'RE GOING
TO BE REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS
AND MAY ADJUST OUR POSITION.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
NAOMI PIGEON, ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPUTER AND COMMUNICATIONS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
LIZZY CUTRONA HERE ON BEHALF OF
TECHNET AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE, LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS. SENATOR ROTH
MOVES THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
NOW APPROACHING HOUR TEN. SO I
WILL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE MEMBERS. OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY OR MADAM CHIEF
COUNSEL, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FILE. ITEM 61. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
UMBERG UMBERG. AYE. WILK NØ.
WILK. NO. ALLEN ASHBY. ASHBY.
AYE CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
DURAZZO DURAZZO. AYE. LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE NIELLO. NIELLO. NO
ROTH. ROTH. AYE. STERN STERN.
AYE. WAHAB 7 TO 2 WITH MEMBERS
MISSING. ALL RIGHT. MR. CHAIR.
YES. SO PUT THAT ON CALL. YES.
JUST FOR THE RECORD, WE'RE FIVE
MINUTES FROM OUR 11. THAT MATH
THING IS HARD, SO. OKAY. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. WE BECOME LAWYERS
BECAUSE WE'RE FEELING MUCH
BETTER ABOUT THE WHOLE HEARING.
SO YOU MENTIONED THAT. SO, YES.
YOU'RE IT'S THE WRONG COMMITTEE
TO BE DOING MATH IN AGREEMENT.
ARE WE READY FOR I THINK THAT
MEANS WE'RE READY FOR FILE ITEM
63. LET'S MOVE IT ALONG. YES
PERFECT. OKAY. ALL RIGHT, AB
3063, FILE 63. YES. PERFECT. HI,
SO I WANT TO AGAIN THANK
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE DILIGENT
WORK ON THIS BILL. AND TO BE
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THE BILL IS, TAKING A LOT OF
AMENDMENTS IN THIS COMMITTEE TO
TRY TO FIND A BALANCE BETWEEN
THE SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION, AND
I'M WE'RE GETTING A LOT CLOSER,
I BELIEVE. BUT YOU'LL HEAR THAT
WE'RE NOT 100% THERE YET. I
DON'T THINK WITH THAT, I'M PROUD
TO PRESENT AB 2930, WHICH IS
MODELED AFTER PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
AI BILL OF RIGHTS, AB 2930
PROTECTS INDIVIDUALS FROM
ALGORITHMIC DISCRIMINATION BY
REQUIRING DEVELOPERS AND USERS
TO ASSESS AUTOMATED DECISION
TOOLS, OR ADTS, FOR
DISCRIMINATORY BIAS AND MITIGATE
ACCORDINGLY. ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IN ADTS HAVE
YIELDED ASTONISHING INSIGHTS. I
AM NOT SOMEBODY WHO BELIEVES WE
SHOULD NOT BE USING ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE FOR THESE PURPOSES.
HOWEVER, I DO THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO BUILD TRUST IN
THESE MODELS AND TO DEPLOY THEM
IN A RESPONSIBLE MANNER. MANNER
AUTOMATED DECISION TOOLS USE
STATISTICAL ANALYSIS TO ASSESS
ELIGIBILITY FOR BENEFITS OR
PENALTIES. DECISIONS THAT HAVE A
DRASTIC IMPACT ON INDIVIDUALS
LIVES. ADTS HAVE BEEN WIDELY
USED FOR EMPLOYMENT, SCREENING
AND HEALTH CARE DECISIONS, AND
THE USE CASE OF THEM CONTINUES
TO EXPAND. A YEAR AGO, IT WAS
SHOWED THAT OVER HALF OF THE
DECISIONS IN YOUR LIFE ARE BEING
MADE BY THESE AI TOOLS ALREADY.
THERE IS NO ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
UNBIASED DATA SETS OR
PROGRAMMERS UNCONSCIOUS BIAS
THAT CAN BE EMBEDDED INTO ADTS,
AND THE RESULTS CAN BE
DETRIMENTAL AND DISCRIMINATORY
AS THE LAW STANDS TODAY, AS ALL
OF YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE TO WAIT
UNTIL SO MANY PEOPLE ARE THE
SUBJECT OF DISCRIMINATION BEFORE
YOU CAN TAKE AN ACTION. AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN, WE'VE SEEN
STUDIES THAT SHOW THAT THESE
TOOLS CAN RESULT IN BIAS IN
SCIENCE. IN 2019, A CLINICAL
ALGORITHM USED ACROSS HOSPITALS
FOR DETERMINING PATIENT CARE WAS
RACIALLY BIASED AGAINST BLACK
PATIENTS. IN THAT CASE, THE
ALGORITHM USED HEALTH CARE
SPENDING AS A PROXY FOR HEALTH
NEEDS AND FALSELY CONCLUDED THAT
BLACK PATIENTS WERE HEALTHIER
THAN EQUALLY SICK WHITE
PATIENTS, DEPRIVING BLACK
PATIENTS FROM THEIR MUCH NEEDED
HEALTH CARE. THIS IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE WHEN YOU CONSIDER ADTS
ARE BEING USED TO DETERMINE
ELIGIBILITY FOR EMPLOYMENT,
MEDICAL TREATMENT, PAROLE,
PROBATION, ETC, IT BECOMES
APPARENT THAT THESE ARE
CONSEQUENTIAL DECISIONS, AND
MARGINALIZATION AND
DISCRIMINATION WILL ONLY BECOME
MORE ENTRENCHED UNLESS WE TEST
THESE TOOLS. AND SO WHAT THIS
BILL DOES FUNDAMENTALLY, IS IT
FOLLOWS THE BEST PRACTICES IN
THE INDUSTRY. MOST GOOD ACTORS
IN THE INDUSTRY ARE DOING IMPACT
ASSESSMENTS BEFORE THEY DEPLOY
THESE TOOLS. THEY ARE MAKING
SURE THEY ARE NONDISCRIMINATORY,
BECAUSE IF YOU HAND A HOUSING
TOOL OVER TO AN APARTMENT OWNER
AND THEY RUN A TOOL AND IT IS
DISCRIMINATORY, THAT IS
UNLAWFUL. AND SO WE ARE JUST
PUTTING THE BEST PRACTICE INTO
PLACE BY SAYING, YOU HAVE TO RUN
THESE IMPACT ASSESSMENTS AND
ENSURE THERE'S NO BIAS BEFORE
YOU DEPLOY THEM. AND THAT IS A
FUTURE THAT I, AS A WOMAN WHO
HAS FACED DISCRIMINATION IN
HIRING, THINK IS AN EXCITING
FUTURE, ONE WHERE WE CAN CREATE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE POTENTIALLY
LESS BIASED THAN THE ONES WE
HAVE TODAY. WITH ME, IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IS CATHERINE BRACY,
CEO AND CO-FOUNDER OF TECH
EQUITY COLLABORATIVE. AND MARIKO
YOSHIHARA IS HERE ON BEHALF OF
TECH EQUITY. AS A TECHNICAL
EXPERT, ONLY ONE PERSON WILL
SPEAK UNLESS YOU ASK QUESTIONS.
AARTI, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY. TECH EQUITY IS A
RESEARCH AND POLICY ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON ENSURING
THAT TECH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
BUILDING PROSPERITY FOR ALL AND
IS HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
HARMS IT CREATES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. ENACTING THE
PROTECTIONS OUTLINED IN AB 2930
ARE CRITICAL AS WE HAVE ALREADY
SEEN, THE HARMFUL AND
DISCRIMINATORY EFFECTS THAT
AUTOMATED DECISION MAKING
SYSTEMS CAN HAVE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AS ASSEMBLYWOMAN
POINTED OUT, EVERYTHING FROM
TOOLS THAT WERE MEANT TO PREDICT
HOW A DEFENDANT IS TO RECIDIVATE
THAT WAS FALSELY FOUND TO
FALSELY FLAG BLACK DEFENDANTS AS
FUTURE CRIMINALS AT TWICE THE
RATE OF WHITE DEFENDANTS TO
SYSTEMS THAT PREDICTABLY SCORE
RENTAL HOUSING APPLICANTS, A LA
MINORITY REPORT ON WHETHER THEY
ARE LIKELY TO PAY RENT ON TIME
OR DAMAGE AN APARTMENT UNIT.
TECH EQUITIES RESEARCH HAS FOUND
THAT THESE PREDICTIVE SCORING
TOOLS, WHICH MAKE GUESSES ABOUT
PEOPLE'S FUTURE BEHAVIOR BASED
ON COMPARISONS TO OTHERS WHO ARE
LIKE THEM, ARE BEING USED BY
ALMOST 20% OF LANDLORDS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT NUMBER IS
GROWING. OUR RESEARCH HAS ALSO
FOUND THAT THESE TOOLS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY,
DISPROPORTIONATELY RELIED UPON
BY LANDLORDS WHO RENT TO MORE
VULNERABLE PEOPLE. THESE TOOLS
OFTEN OPERATE AS BLACK BOXES
THAT OFFER NO WAY FOR IMPACTED
PEOPLE TO KNOW, CORRECT OR
DISPUTE THE RESULTS OR
UNDERSTAND THE LOGIC BEHIND A
RECOMMENDATION OR PREDICTION. AB
2930 WILL PROVIDE CONSUMERS AND
WORKERS WITH MORE INFORMATION
AND GREATER TRANSPARENCY INTO
THE USE OF THESE TOOLS FOR
CRITICAL AREAS OF THEIR LIVES,
WHILE REQUIRING DEVELOPERS AND
DEPLOYERS TO TAKE MORE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR REDUCING THE
LIKELIHOOD OF DISCRIMINATION. WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BARKAN'S LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE, AND HER
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION PROVIDES MEANINGFUL
PROTECTIONS TO THOSE IMPACTED BY
AIDS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN ON THE BILL,
AND WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
AMENDMENTS MADE THUS FAR. FOR
THIS REASON, WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS, OTHER
WITNESSES. OH, GO AHEAD, MARIKA
YOSHIHARA, JUST HERE, AS A
TECHNICAL WITNESS, BUT ALSO WANT
TO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION, EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES, CENTER FOR DEMOCRACY
AND TECHNOLOGY, CONSUMER
REPORTS, AND EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES. I DON'T KNOW IF I
SAID THAT ALREADY. ALRIGHTY.
THEY'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF. YES.
RIGHT. OKAY, ALL RIGHT. OTHERS
IN SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GOOD EVENING. TERI
ELY WITH ECONOMIC SECURITY
ACTION AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE, LET'S
NOW TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB, YEAH. THAT
1 TO 2930. PLEASE APPROACH. HOW
MANY BILLS ARE FINALLY AT THE
TABLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. AND TO THE AUTHOR, ONCE
AGAIN WITH CAL CHAMBER
UNFORTUNATELY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB 2930, BIAS AND
DISCRIMINATION ARE ABSOLUTELY
SERIOUS PROBLEMS. AND SO OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES ARE TRYING TO
BE PART OF THE SOLUTION. BUT WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT'S IMPERATIVE
TO BE PART TO TAKE A MEASURED
APPROACH TO AVOID OVERREGULATION
OF TOOLS THAT ALSO CONTRIBUTED
MANY POSITIVE AND VALUABLE WAYS
TO OUR ECONOMY AND SOCIETY,
TOOLS THAT ACTUALLY HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO REDUCE BIAS AND
DISCRIMINATION. WITH THAT BIGGER
PICTURE IN MIND, WE HAVE
ACTUALLY DATING BACK TO AB 331
WORKED ON IDENTIFYING THE MAJOR
ISSUES COMPLIANCE ISSUES OR
CHALLENGES, OVER REGULATION,
EXAMPLES TO TRY AND GET TO A
PLACE OF NEUTRALITY ON THIS
BILL. FIRST, THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL IS EXTRAORDINARILY BROAD.
IT CAPTURES BUSINESSES OF ALL
SIZES AND INDUSTRIES, BUT ALSO
ALL KINDS OF AT LOW AND HIGH
RISK AND LARGE PART DUE TO THE
BROAD AND VAGUE DEFINITIONS IN
THE BILL. NEXT, THERE'S THE
ENFORCEABILITY OF NOTICE AND OPT
OUT PROVISIONS FOLLOWED BY THE
NEED FOR GREATER CONFIDENTIALITY
TO ENSURE CANDOR, THE NEED FOR A
SINGLE ENFORCER TO ENSURE
CONSISTENT APPLICATION OF THE
LAW, AND PREEMPTION. THE HARDER
QUESTION, OF COURSE, HAS BEEN
HOW TO ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES CONSISTENT WITH OUR
COMMITMENT TO THE AUTHOR, WE
WORK DILIGENTLY WITH MEMBERS AND
INDUSTRY PARTNERS ON AMENDMENTS
THAT WOULD ADDRESS OUR
OVERLAPPING CONCERNS, MEANING
NOT JUST RED LINES THAT ADDRESS
CAL CHAMBERS CONCERNS AND OUR
MEMBERS CONCERNS, BUT THOSE OF
THE BROADER INDUSTRY. THIS WAS A
DIFFICULT TASK, AND TOOK TIME,
AND WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
PATIENCE, BUT WE DID KEEP OUR
WORD AND WE PROVIDED THOSE
AMENDMENTS ON MAY 8TH, AND WE
PROVIDED THEM TO THE COMMITTEE,
OF COURSE, ON JUNE 5TH AS WELL.
AND WE EVEN FLAGGED WITHIN THOSE
A SUBSET OF THE RED LINES THAT
CORRESPOND TO THOSE FIVE KEY
ISSUES THAT ARE KEEPING US FROM
IDEALLY GETTING TO A GOOD PLACE
ON THIS BILL TO UNDERSTAND HOW
SERIOUSLY WE HAVE TAKEN THIS,
YOU JUST NEED TO LOOK AT SOME OF
THE OTHER ISSUES, LIKE PENALTIES
IN THE BILL THAT WE DID NOT
PRIORITIZE, WHICH WE ORDINARILY
WOULD. OF COURSE, WE'RE DEEPLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS INCORPORATING OUR
REQUESTED CONFIDENTIALITY
PROVISIONS AND MOST OF OUR
CHANGES TO THE ALGORITHMIC
DISCRIMINATION DEFINITION, WHICH
IS KEY, AND I DON'T WANT TO
UNDERMINE THAT. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, MORE AMENDMENTS
REMAIN, AND THE MAJORITY OF THE
AMENDMENTS HAVE CONSISTENTLY
TAKEN US FURTHER APART ON A BILL
THAT IMPACTS BUSINESSES OF ALL
SIZES AND INDUSTRIES. IT DOES
NOT REFLECT A FAIR COMPROMISE
FROM OUR PERCEPTION, AND SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING. YES,
ADVOCATING A NO. WE ARE
ADVOCATING A NO, BUT APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU. RIGHT.
IT'S A CONSIDERATE NO, BUT A NO.
GOT IT. NO, CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS REMY
MORALES, AND I AM THE CO-FOUNDER
AND CEO OF ZELLA LIFE. ZELLA
LIFE IS AN AI POWERED COACHING
PLATFORM THAT HELPS STRENGTHEN
EMOTIONAL INTELLIGENCE AND SOFT
SKILLS IN THE WORKPLACE. OUR AI
TOOL ACTUALLY HELPS COMPANIES
PREVENT AND REDUCE WORKPLACE
BIAS AND DISCRIMINATION. PLEASE
NOTE THAT I 100% AGREE WITH AB
2930 INTENT, BUT IT SIMPLY
MISSES THE MARK. UNFORTUNATELY,
AB 2930 WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY
LIMIT OUR ABILITY TO HELP
DEVELOP UNDER THE
UNDERREPRESENTED WORKFORCE
GROUPS THAT WE SERVE BY
LEGISLATING FROM A PLACE OF
FEAR. THIS BILL IMPOSES
EXTRAORDINARY AND UNJUSTIFIED
BURDENS, ESPECIALLY ON SMALL
COMPANIES LIKE MINE. INSTEAD OF
FOCUSING ON ACTUAL
DISCRIMINATION, THE BILL IMPOSES
RISK ASSESSMENTS, PREDICTIONS,
EVALUATIONS, GOVERNANCE PROGRAMS
AND REVIEWS IN A NOBLE BUT
MISGUIDED EFFORT TO PREVENT
DISCRIMINATION. THE GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T IMPOSE THESE BURDENS ON
PEOPLE WHO USE THEIR BRAINS OR
CALCULATORS TO MAKE CRITICAL
DECISIONS, NOR BUSINESSES THAT
GET DECISION SUPPORT FROM
CONSULTANTS. SO WHY WOULD THE
GOVERNMENT BURY COMPANIES LIKE
MINE IN PAPERWORK, WHO USE
TECHNOLOGY RESPONSIBLY TO
PROCESS LARGE DATA SETS TO HELP
COMPANIES AND PEOPLE MAKE BETTER
DECISIONS? ULTIMATELY, THIS BILL
WOULD RESULT IN HEFTY FINES AND
PENALTIES FOR BUSINESSES THAT
ARE NOT ENGAGING IN
DISCRIMINATION, BUT SIMPLY
FAILING TO MEET ALL STRICT
REQUIREMENTS. IF THIS BILL
BECOMES A LAW, I WILL HAVE TO
HIRE EXPENSIVE LEGAL AND
COMPLIANCE EXPERTS TO SATISFY
ALL OF THE ADMIN REQUIREMENTS. I
EMPATHIZE DEEPLY WITH CONCERNS
ABOUT DISCRIMINATION AND BIAS,
BUT I URGE YOU TO FOCUS ON
REGULATING AI MISUSE THAT
RESULTS IN ACTUAL HARM. THE
MEANS OF DISCRIMINATION. THE
TECHNOLOGY SHOULD NOT BE YOUR
FOCUS. UNLAWFUL DISCRIMINATION
IS WRONG. WHETHER IT IS
ACCOMPLISHED WITH A COMPUTER, A
PHONE OR A PENCIL AND PAPER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. I SEE QUITE A LINE
FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. IN
FACT, I'M HALF TEMPTED JUST TO
HAVE YOU ALL YELL AT AT ONE
TIME. BUT NO, I'M NOT GOING TO
DO THAT. OKAY. GO AHEAD. KRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. UNLESS THE BILL GETS
STRONGER. THANK YOU. OPPOSITE OF
THAT. WE'VE GOT PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES WHO ARE UNHAPPY WITH THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. WE ARE
ENCOURAGED BY THE AMENDMENTS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU.
CATHERINE CHARLES, ON BEHALF OF
THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA, STILL
OPPOSE, BUT WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS AND LOOKING
FORWARD TO POSSIBLE AMENDMENTS
IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU, MIKE
ROBSON HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN STAFFING ASSOCIATION,
THE CALIFORNIA STAFFING
PROFESSIONALS OPPOSED TO THE
BILL, UNLESS IT'S AMENDED TO
BECOME FEASIBLE. THANK YOU,
INDIRA MCDONALD. ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MORTGAGE BANKERS
ASSOCIATION ASSOCIATION. AND WE
ARE OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED, THE
TELLER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED COURTNEY
JENSEN ON BEHALF OF CIVIL
JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION, AND
ALSO VERIZON AND OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. THANK YOU,
LIZZIE KUTSUNA HERE ON BEHALF OF
TECHNET IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. MARK
FAROOQ, CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED, GEORGE SOROS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
OPPOSED, UNLESS AMENDED. RON
VERDUGO, ON BEHALF OF KAISER
PERMANENTE. OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED, DAVID GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF AMERICA'S PHYSICIAN
GROUPS AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES, OPPOSED, UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING. MELANIE CUEVAS.
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO OPPOSED, UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING. NAOMI
PEDRO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
WITH OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION, AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES, OPPOSED. MARGARET
GLADSTEIN, ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN PROPERTY AND CASUALTY
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION, IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD EVENING,
STEPHANIE MOORE, ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION, IN OPPOSITION.
MOIRA, TOP, ON BEHALF OF ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION, JOHN WENGER, ON
BEHALF OF THE ADVANCED MEDICAL
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION, OPPOSED,
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING
THE MICROPHONE, WE'RE GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO MEMBERS. AND
BEFORE WE BRING IT BACK TO
MEMBERS, I'LL JUST MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT. I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL, BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE SOME VERY, VERY, VERY
BIG ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
RESOLVED. AND I HAVE CONFIDENCE
THE BILL, IF IT SHOULD PASS OUT
OF COMMITTEE, IS GOING TO GO TO
OUR OWN EXPERT. SENATOR
CABALLERO, ON ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND DECISION MAKING
TOOLS, BUT BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT I, AM TRANSPARENT
THAT THAT IF THESE ISSUES AREN'T
RESOLVED, I WON'T SUPPORT IT ON
THE FLOOR. I THINK THAT THERE
ARE SOME THINGS HERE THAT MAKE
IT UNWORKABLE. AND SO I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT IT BEING
WORKABLE BY THE TIME IT GETS TO
THE FLOOR. I KNOW WE'VE GOT AT
LEAST A MONTH TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. I HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THE
AUTHOR. I HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THE
PROCESS. BUT I WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT. ALL RIGHT, NOW
TURNING IT OVER TO MEMBERS,
SENATOR ROTH. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. YOU KNOW, I SUPPORT
CERTAINLY THE IMPACT ASSESSMENT.
WE'VE ACTUALLY WE'VE DONE THAT
FOR YEARS. YOU KNOW, AND
STANDARDIZED TESTS. YOU DON'T
GIVE A TEST UNLESS THE TEST HAS
BEEN VALIDATED TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S NOT DISPARATE IMPACT
WITH RESPECT TO THE TEST
QUESTIONS. AND THERE ARE
PROBABLY NUMEROUS OTHER EXAMPLES
THAT DATE BACK LONG BEFORE THE
LETTERS A AND I WERE LINKED
TOGETHER TO MAKE SOMETHING, I
DO, I DO HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT
THIS ALTERNATIVE SELECTION
PROCESS. SO IF, IF, IF YOU HAVE
A BANKING LENDER AND THEY HAVE A
CONSUMER CREDIT OPERATION AND
THEY PROCESS, LET'S SAY, A
THOUSAND CREDIT APPLICATIONS A
DAY AND THEY USE ONE OF THESE
DECISION MAKING TOOLS, AND
THEY'VE DONE THE IMPACT
ASSESSMENT AND THE IMPACT
ASSESSMENT COMES BACK. NO
DISPARATE IMPACT AND Ã OKAY.
BUT YOU HAVE, AN INDIVIDUAL
REQUEST TO BE SUBJECTED TO AN
ALTERNATIVE SELECTION PROCESS.
HOW DOES THAT WORK? IN THAT
CASE, MAYBE IT'S NOT A THOUSAND.
MAYBE IT'S 5000 CREDIT
APPLICATIONS A DAY BECAUSE IT'S
SOME BIGGER BANK FOR EXAMPLE.
YEAH. AND I WANT TO SO THAT
LANGUAGE, WHEN WE CRAFTED THE
LANGUAGE WE PUT IF TECHNICALLY
FEASIBLE TO ADDRESS THAT, IT'S
BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION IN THE
BANKING INDUSTRY SPECIFICALLY.
AND, HOPEFULLY THEY'LL BACK ME
UP, BUT WE ARE IN SERIOUS
CONVERSATION WITH THEM BECAUSE
THEY HAVE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE FEDERALLY BACKED LOANS
HAVE TO USE FEDERAL TECHNOLOGIES
IN ORDER TO BE PROCESSED. AND SO
WE ARE, I THINK, VERY CLOSE ON
LANGUAGE WITH THE BANKING
INDUSTRY SPECIFICALLY. SO I JUST
WANTED TO TOUCH ON THAT BECAUSE,
YOU COULD YOU COULD SUBSTITUTE
SOMETHING. YES YES. SO I WANT TO
START WITH BANKING JUST BECAUSE
I DIDN'T KNOW IF OTHERS HAD
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT
BANKING. BUT I'LL, I'LL GO MORE
BROADLY AFTER THAT. I JUST
WANTED TO BECAUSE BOTH THE
SPECIFIC QUESTION AND THE BROAD
QUESTION, TECHNICALLY, YOU COULD
HIRE MORE PEOPLE. AND YOU KNOW,
HAVE 150 OF THEM SCREENING
PIECES OF PAPER IN A ROOM, AND
THAT WOULD BE TECHNICALLY
FEASIBLE. RIGHT. BUT NOT VERY
PRACTICAL IF YOU WANT TO HAVE
TIMELY RESPONSE TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRYING TO DO DEALS. SO HOW
DO WE DEAL WITH THAT IN THE
CONTEXT OF THIS? IS THERE YES.
MOVE AFOOT. YES. SO WE'RE
CONTINUING TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
LIKE I SAID, WE THOUGHT
TECHNICALLY FEASIBLE WORK. TO
YOUR POINT, WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF
THE OPPOSITION, AROUND THAT
SPECIFIC PIECE. AND SO WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO DO
THAT WHERE IT IS POSSIBLE, WHERE
IT DOES MAKE SENSE THAT SOMEBODY
MIGHT WANT TO OPT OUT OF THESE
TOOLS, AND, YOU KNOW, I MEAN, I
THINK THERE'S AN EXAMPLE
RECENTLY OF A TOOL THAT IS USED
ACROSS DIFFERENT EMPLOYERS. AND
SOMEBODY HAD APPLIED TO JOB
AFTER JOB WHERE THEY WERE USING
THE SAME TOOL, AND THAT PERSON
KEPT GETTING REJECTED OVER AND
OVER AGAIN. AND THAT PERSON
CAN'T GET AN ANSWER AS TO WHY
THIS TOOL KEEPS REJECTING THEM.
RIGHT. AND THEY CAN'T GET A
HUMAN TO REVIEW THEIR
APPLICATION BEFORE THEY GET
REJECTED. AND SO, YOU KNOW, I DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE
HAVE A WAY TO IDENTIFY THAT, TO
UNDERSTAND IT, TO DEAL WITH IT.
BUT TO YOUR POINT, THE LAST
THING I WANT TO DO, AND THAT'S
WHY FROM THE VERY BEGINNING OF
THIS LEGISLATION, YOU KNOW, THE
BIGGEST BUSINESSES THAT MAKE
THESE TOOLS HAVE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH ME ON THIS.
HOW DO YOU DO THESE IMPACT
ASSESSMENT? WHAT'S IN THESE
IMPACT ASSESSMENTS SO THAT THIS
IS NOT BEYOND THE SCOPE OF WHAT
AGAIN, NOT EVERYBODY'S DOING,
BUT BEST IN CLASS IS DOING. AND
I THINK IT IS OKAY FOR US TO ASK
EVERYONE TO RISE TO BEST IN
CLASS. BUT WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THAT OPT
OUT LANGUAGE. AND I HEAR IT. AND
TO THE CHAIR'S POINT, YOU KNOW,
I THINK, THE EXPERT THAT WILL
SEE IT NEXT WILL, YOU KNOW,
HOPEFULLY BE SEEING SOME OF THAT
AND THEN JUST ONE OTHER, BELIEVE
ME, I'M GOING TO SUPPORT. YES
THANK YOU SENATOR. ONE OTHER,
ONE OTHER POINT. YOU SAW SOME
HEALTH CARE PEOPLE IN HERE SEEM
TO ME I SEEM TO RECALL THAT IN A
HEALTH CARE ENVIRONMENT, WE HAD
SOME LEGISLATION RECENTLY WHERE
IF ONE OF THESE DECISION MAKING
TOOLS WAS UTILIZED IN A HEALTH
CARE SETTING, THERE HAD TO BE, A
LIVE HEALTH CARE PERSON WHO
REVIEWED THE RESULTS BEFORE THE
ACTION WAS TAKEN. YOU MIGHT WANT
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AND
FIGURE OUT HOW YOU BUILD SOME OF
THAT IN HERE, BECAUSE IF
LEGISLATION IS ALREADY PASSED,
OR PEOPLE ALREADY DOING IT, THEN
MAYBE THEY DON'T. MAYBE THERE'S
A THEY DON'T NEED TO BE
SUBJECTED TO THIS. AND THAT IS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE ARE
HOPEFUL WE ARE. RIGHT. BUT
CONTINUING TO HEAR ABOUT, WHICH
IS THAT AND THIS IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I THINK THE CHAMBER
HAS BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
US ABOUT, WHICH IS, IF A HUMAN
IS MAKING THE DECISION. SO IF
YOU'RE USING, FOR EXAMPLE, A
CREDIT CHECK, BUT YOU'RE THE
LANDLORD AND YOU'RE MAKING THE
DECISION, THE CREDIT CHECK
DOESN'T COUNT UNDER THIS BILL.
IT ACTUALLY HAS TO BE A TOOL
THAT IS MAKING THE DECISION. SO
IN A IN A MEDICAL SETTING WHERE
YOU'RE USING A TOOL TO HELP
ADVISE YOU, BUT YOU HAVE A
PHYSICIAN, A NURSE PRACTITIONER,
WHOEVER THE CASE MAY BE THAT'S
MAKING THE DECISION. THIS DOES
NOT APPLY. SO THE TOOL HAS TO BE
THE PRIMARY DECISION MAKER. I
WOULD A SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR IN
MAKING THE DECISION. THAT'S THE
LANGUAGE. I'M NOT AN EXPERT. I
SUSPECT THEY MAY USE A TOOL, FOR
EXAMPLE, IN UTILIZING
UTILIZATION REVIEW TO DETERMINE
WHEN IT'S TIME FOR TO DISCHARGE
PATIENT A, BUT THAT DECISION
THEN HAVING BEEN IDENTIFIED BY
THE TOOL THEN HAS TO BE REVIEWED
BEFORE THEY GIVE YOU YOUR
WALKING PAPERS. RIGHT? OKAY. AS
LONG AS YOU'RE TAKING A LOOK.
YES, YES. PERFECT. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. MR. CHAIR. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ROTH. OTHER
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS? SENATOR
CABALLERO, THEN SENATOR BARRASSO
OH, WAIT. SO I, I'VE TAKEN THE
POSITION IN THIS COMMITTEE THAT
I TRY TO FOLLOW THE CHAIR, HE'S
GOT A TOUGH, ROAD TO HOE. AND
WITH AS MANY ASSEMBLY BILLS AS
CAME OVER, THIS WAS A TOUGH THIS
WAS A TOUGH WEEK, BUT, BUT I AM
AS CONCERNED AS THE CHAIR. AND
PART OF IT IS, IS WE'RE BREAKING
NEW GROUND AND WE'RE NOT
CREATING A THE SYSTEM IS NOT
UTILIZING THE, THE CIVIL RIGHTS
STATUTE THAT DEALS WITH
DISCRIMINATION. IT'S CREATING
ITS OWN CATEGORY, IF YOU WILL.
IN MY MIND. AND, AND SO I, I
HEARD WHAT YOU HAD TO SAY IN
REGARDS TO SOME OF THE CONCERNS,
SMALL BUSINESSES, PENALTIES,
COMPLIANCE EXPERTS, AND, AND
ACTUAL HARM AS OPPOSED TO, A,
WELL, ACTUAL HARM AS OPPOSED TO
UNLAWFUL DISCRIMINATION OR, OR
LOOKING AT IT AS UNLAWFUL
DISCRIMINATION. SO I'M JUST
CONCERNED BECAUSE, I, I SEE
WHERE YOU'RE TRYING TO GO, I
APPRECIATE IT, BUT I ALSO THINK
THAT WE NEED TO, TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT DISCOURAGING SMALL
STARTUPS HERE, THAT WE, WE GIVE
PEOPLE A RIGHT TO FIX WHATEVER
WE THINK THE PROBLEM IS, AND
THAT THE PENALTY SHOULD ONLY
ACCRUE IF THERE'S BEEN ACTUAL
HARM OR INTENTIONAL IN TERMS OF
HOW THE MODEL IS CREATED SO THAT
IT, SO THAT IT COULD HAVE BEEN
EASILY FIXED. IT COULD HAVE BEEN
EASILY IDENTIFIED WITH A, WITH A
COMPLIANCE, THE COMPLIANCE WORK
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. SO IT
JUST MY THOUGHTS RIGHT NOW I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT, THE
RECOMMENDATION AND I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL, BUT I, I, I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL
EXACTLY HOW WE UTILIZE THIS.
AND, AND AS WE, WE HAVE THE
INDUSTRY DEVELOPING THAT WE
DON'T GO DOWN A ROAD WHERE WE
BECOME REALLY PUNITIVE IN A WAY
THAT, THAT ENDS UP DISCOURAGING,
WHAT WE WANT IS WE WANT THE
BANKS TO BE ABLE TO DETERMINE
WHO SHOULD GET A LOAN AND WHO
SHOULDN'T. BUT WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE NOT
DISCRIMINATING. AND THEY HAVEN'T
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN LAZY OR, HOW
THEY'VE CREATED THE AI SYSTEM
HAS NOT BEEN, INTENTIONALLY
UTILIZING DATA THAT HAS RACIAL
BIAS IN IT OR RACIAL OR GENDER
FOR THAT MATTER. SO ANYWAY, I'M
KIND OF RAMBLING, BUT THERE'S
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT I HAD SOME CONCERN ABOUT.
CONCERNS ABOUT AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION IN THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR RUSSELL,
YOU AND SENATOR ROTH WERE
ALREADY TALKING ABOUT THE HEALTH
CARE INDUSTRY, SO I JUST WANTED
TO SPECIFICALLY, YOU KNOW, ASK
YOU ABOUT THAT, AND THEN IN THE
IT'S NOT JUST LIMITED TO THE
HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY, BUT I
NOTICED THE NURSES ASSOCIATION
IS CONCERNED ABOUT, PROTECTING
THE RIGHTS OF WORKERS UNDER
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT.
AND THAT CUTS ACROSS ANY
INDUSTRY. BUT THEY SPECIFICALLY
COMING OUT OF THE HEALTH CARE
INDUSTRY, I THOUGHT THERE WOULD
BE THAT CONNECTION. SO IF YOU
HAVE ANYTHING ON THAT AND THEN
SECOND IS I THINK THERE'S BEEN
REFERENCE TO THIS IS WE'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF BILLS, AI BILLS, COME
THROUGH THE, THE COMMITTEE, AND
I'M JUST WONDERING HOW AT THE
END OF THE DAY, YOU KNOW, HOW DO
ALL THESE BILLS INTERACT AND
HAVE YOU THOUGHT AS YOU
INTRODUCED IT OR NOW, AS A
RESULT OF GETTING THE FEEDBACK,
HOW DOES AUTOMATIC AUTOMATED,
DECISION TOOLS, HOW DOES THAT
COMPETE WITH OTHER BILLS OR WITH
REGULATIONS THAT AN AGENCY MAY
BE WORKING FOR? SO ANY THOUGHTS
ON THOSE TWO? YES, SO I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. I WANT TO
BE INCREDIBLY CLEAR TO TECH
EQUITY'S CREDIT, THEY CREATED A
ROUND TABLE, IF YOU WILL, OF
FOLKS THAT LABOR WAS ABSOLUTELY
AT. SO THEY HAVE BROUGHT THEIR
INPUT TO THE TABLE, WHICH I
THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THEY PROTECT OUR
WORKERS, AND NOTHING IN THIS
BILL WOULD PREVENT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING WOULD INTERFERE WITH
THAT PROCESS. THIS BILL MERELY
TALKS ABOUT BASICALLY TESTING
THESE THINGS BEFORE THEY'RE
DEPLOYED. AND SO, WE DID TALK TO
COUNSEL ABOUT THAT. AND WE'LL GO
BACK. BUT WE DON'T THINK THAT
THIS INTERFERES WITH THAT AT
ALL. SO JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT'S CLEAR THAT THAT'S THERE
AT THE TABLE. WE'RE HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION FIRST AND FOREMOST,
AND THEN AS IT'S INTERESTING,
YOU ASKED THAT QUESTION ABOUT AI
BILLS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER DIXON
ASKED THAT QUESTION EARLIER IN
MY COMMITTEE TODAY, IT'S AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION, AND I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING IT'S I MEAN, YOU
HEARD ME COMPLIMENT CHRISTIAN AT
THE BEGINNING OF THIS BECAUSE,
SINCE BEFORE WE STARTED HEARING
BILLS IN FEBRUARY, YOU KNOW, OUR
STAFFS WORKING TOGETHER TO MAKE
SURE WE WERE TRYING TO DRIVE
TRAINS IN THE SAME DIRECTION AND
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF WORK THAT
THE STAFF HAVE DONE TO DO THAT.
AND I'M REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THAT
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT. AND SO YES, YOU KNOW,
THIS BILL IS IN ITS SECOND YEAR,
AND I THINK THAT, AS FOR THOSE
OTHER BILLS THAT ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT AND I'VE SUPPORTED AND
I THINK ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
AND THE PRIVACY AGENCY IS DOING
REGULATIONS PART OF THE REASON
WE'RE CONTINUING TO MOVE THIS IS
THE PRIVACY REGULATIONS ARE NOT
ENTIRELY, I THINK, IN LINE WITH
WHAT I THINK OUR LEGISLATIVE
INTENT IS, AND THAT'S WHAT WE AS
A LEGISLATURE GET TO DECIDE, BUT
WE ARE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEM. THE DEFINITION OF AI THAT
WAS MOVED THROUGH BOTH
COMMITTEES ALREADY IS ALIGNED,
SO THAT WE'RE MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S NOT INCONSISTENCY, BUT,
YOU KNOW, I THINK THE CRITICAL
POINT HERE AND THIS ADDRESSES A
LITTLE BIT OF WHAT SENATOR
CABALLERO SAID, IS THAT THE BILL
FUNDAMENTALLY SAYS THAT IF
YOU'RE CREATING A TOOL THAT
MAKES A CONSEQUENTIAL DECISION
AND WE LIST THOSE RIGHT. SO
HOUSING, HEALTH CARE,
EMPLOYMENT, THE THINGS THAT WE
FUNDAMENTALLY NEED IN OUR LIVES
AND THE TOOL ITSELF IS GOING TO
MAKE THAT DECISION. SO NOT A NOT
A DOCTOR, NOT A LANDLORD, BUT
THE TOOL YOU HAVE TO TEST IT,
YOU HAVE TO DO AN IMPACT
ASSESSMENT. AND, AND THEN WE CAN
ASK FOR THAT IMPACT ASSESSMENT
AS A GOVERNMENT. AND WE CAN MAKE
SURE YOU'RE DOING YOUR DILIGENCE
TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE NOT PUTTING
DISCRIMINATORY TOOLS OUT INTO
THE WORLD. AND I ACTUALLY THINK
THAT AND WE TOOK OUT THERE WAS A
PRA I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR, I
TOOK OUT THE PRA, WHICH I KNOW
THE CHAIR WOULD HAVE HAD ME TAKE
IT ANYWAYS, BUT WE DID THAT SO
WE ARE TRYING TO BE INCREDIBLY
THOUGHTFUL THAT THIS DOESN'T
OVERLAP WITH CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS.
CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS ARE IMPORTANT.
I'M NOT TOUCHING THEM. THE AG
ASKS THAT WE CLARIFY THAT AND WE
HAVE, THIS MERELY SAYS THAT IF
YOU'RE GOING TO USE THESE TOOLS
AND YOU'RE GOING TO BUY THESE
TOOLS, YOU'RE GOING TO KNOW THEY
WERE TESTED, AND WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE TESTED.
AND I JUST DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S THAT MUCH TO ASK,
ESPECIALLY SINCE YOU CAN ASK
WORKDAY, MICROSOFT, OTHERS,
THEY'RE DOING THIS. I'M NOT
ACTUALLY ASKING THEM TO DO
ANYTHING BEYOND WHAT THEY ARE
ALREADY DOING TODAY. AND SO
AGAIN, THERE IS NUANCE ACROSS
INDUSTRIES ABOUT THE OPT OUT,
ABOUT OTHER THINGS. BUT I THINK
THAT ASKING THEM TO DO THAT AND
ASKING THEM TO TURN IT OVER WHEN
WE ASK FOR IT AGAIN, AND
PROTECTING THEIR TRADE SECRETS,
WHICH WE WORKED REALLY HARD TO
GET. RIGHT, YOU KNOW, I THINK IS
REALLY NOT EARTH SHATTERING
LEGISLATION OR INCREDIBLY
BURDENSOME. I THINK IT IS WHAT
OUR COMMUNITIES WILL NEED,
BECAUSE IF AI INNOVATION IS
GOING TO HAPPEN, COMMUNITIES
NEED TO TRUST IT. AND I THINK
THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IS
BUILDING TRUST. AND SO WE'VE
WORKED REALLY HARD TO TRY TO
MAKE IT, NARROW. AND, YOU KNOW,
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT. I
KNOW THAT ROSE PROBABLY CRINGING
WHEN I SAY NARROW, BUT, YOU
KNOW, I THINK WE ARE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THE OBLIGATIONS ON
INDUSTRY ARE ACCEPTABLE. I WILL
ALSO NOTE WE HAVE A SMALL
BUSINESS EXCEPTION IN HERE, SO
THAT IS SOMETHING WE CONSIDERED
AND PUT INTO THE LANGUAGE. SO
I'VE WORKED REALLY HARD TO TRY
TO REACH THAT BALANCE. AND I
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE ARE NOT
THERE. SO I DON'T WANT TO I
DON'T WANT TO MIS STATE WHAT IS
SAID, BUT THAT IS THE GOAL. ALL
RIGHT. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SENATOR STERN? THANKS,
I KNOW WE'RE YEAH, 11TH HOUR OR
WHATEVER HOUR IT IS, BUT,
APPRECIATE YOU GOING INTO
DETAILS ON ALL THIS AND TAKING
ON A BIG ISSUE, TRYING TO CAST A
WIDE NET, NOT JUST PICKING AN
INDUSTRY BY INDUSTRY, BUT
ACTUALLY WORKING THROUGH THE
WHOLE ISSUE, IT'S A IT'S REALLY
A NECESSARY ENDEAVOR. SO I
APPLAUD YOU FOR ALL THE DETAILED
WORK. I'M JUST TRYING TO I THINK
SOME OF MY QUESTIONS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN ANSWERED. I GUESS
MAYBE JUST TO PUT A FINE POINT
ON A FEW. SO IT SOUNDS LIKE THIS
OPT OUT QUESTION ON THE MORTGAGE
SIDE OF THINGS. YOU'RE WORKING
ON IT, TRYING TO LAND THAT, THE
CONCERN WAS ABOUT IF EVERYTHING
WENT TO MANUAL UNDERWRITING,
THEN SUDDENLY, YOU KNOW, EVEN
LIKE OUR OWN, OUR OWN STATE
AGENCIES CAN'T PROCESS THESE
MORTGAGES. SO THAT WOULD BE A
PROBLEM, SO I APPRECIATE THAT,
THAT, EFFORT TO TRY TO LAND THAT
PIECE, TO SENATOR RUSSO'S POINT
ON THE NURSES ASSOCIATION
QUESTION, THIS THIS NOTION OF
LIKE, SORT OF I THINK THE
ESSENCE WAS, WAS A POST HIRING
EMPLOYMENT RELATED ADTS SO THAT
IT WASN'T JUST ON THE FRONT END
OF TRYING TO FIND THE JOB. BUT
ONCE YOU ALREADY HAVE THE JOB,
USING THAT DOES THAT IS THAT
WHERE YOU'RE SORT OF SAYING
YOU'RE HEADING, OR IS THAT
GETTING AHEAD OF WHERE YOU'RE
HEADING ON THAT ON THE POST?
SORRY. ON SO ON THE ON ON ON
EXCLUDING POST HIRING,
EMPLOYMENT RELATED DECISIONS
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
REALLY CONCERNED ON THE FRONT
END OF PEOPLE GETTING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST. BUT IS
THAT WHEN YOU SAY WE HAVE LABOR
AT THE TABLE, IS THAT IS THAT
WHERE YOU REALLY DON'T WANT TO
SPEAK FOR, FOR LABOR? BUT WE
WE'VE BEEN IN COALITION HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM. I THINK
THE ISSUE IS THAT DEFINITELY ON
THE PRE HIRING, LIKE WHEN THIS
IS USED PRE HIRING, THAT'S WHERE
WE REALLY SEE A DISCRIMINATORY
IMPACT A DISPARATE IMPACT.
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER ISSUES
WHEN YOU ARE NOW EMPLOYED WHERE
TOOLS ARE BEING USED ADT IS
BEING USED NOT NECESSARILY IN A
IN A WAY THAT IS GOING TO BE
DISCRIMINATORY BASED ON YOUR
RACE, GENDER, BUT IT HAS IMPACTS
ON THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
JOB OR HOW A PERSON'S PAID. AND
THERE ARE ALL THESE OTHER
IMPACTS THAT I THINK, FROM AN
EMPLOYMENT PERSPECTIVE, THERE'S
JUST WE NEED TO MAKE SURE ALL OF
THAT'S COVERED, TOO. AND SO
THAT'S, THAT'S WHERE SOME OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS ARE
HAPPENING. HOW CAN WE MAKE SURE
THAT, YES, WE WANT
DISCRIMINATION COVERED TOO, BUT
LET'S MAKE SURE SOME OF THE
OTHER THINGS ARE COVERED AS
WELL. SO IF I'M UNDERSTANDING
THAT NOT NECESSARILY PLANNING TO
EXCLUDE, THEN POST HIRING,
EMPLOYMENT RELATED ADS. BUT SOME
OTHER THIRD WAY HERE WHERE IT'S
NOT EXCLUDED BUT YOU'RE I DON'T
KNOW WHAT TRYING TO NUANCE THAT.
YEAH SO JUST TO GET A SENSE I
DON'T OKAY. SO AND THEY ARE I
MEAN TO BE CLEAR THEY'RE STILL
IN A SUPPORT POSITION BECAUSE WE
ARE IN CONVERSATION WITH THEM.
SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE.
YEP. UNDERSTOOD I'M JUST SORT OF
YEAH. YEAH. WE'RE WE'RE HAVING,
SO IN TERMS OF THE WHOLE
COALITION, THERE'S QUITE A FEW
OF US. WE'RE TRYING TO GET
EVERYONE, YOU KNOW, INTO
SUPPORT. SO WE'RE HAVING A LOT
OF CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE ON, YOU KNOW,
WHAT THAT WOULD ENTAIL. BUT I DO
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SEPARATE
CONVERSATIONS JUST GENERALLY
HAVING A BILL FOR EMPLOYMENT AND
WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE. AND
SO I THINK THERE'S JUST
CONVERSATIONS ON HOW THIS BILL
FITS IN WITH WITH THAT. I MEAN,
IDEALLY THESE TOOLS CAN ACTUALLY
HELP EMPLOYERS MAKE THE
WORKPLACE BETTER FOR EMPLOYEES.
AND THAT, I MEAN, I KNOW IT
WOULDN'T CREATE AS MANY JOBS FOR
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS, BUT THAT WE
CAN, YOU KNOW, OBVIATE THE NEED
FOR AS MANY HOURLY VIOLATIONS,
AS MUCH WAGE THEFT, YOU KNOW,
WORKPLACE DISCRIMINATION, THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS. SO IDEALLY, WE
CAN TURN THESE TOOLS TO OUR
BENEFIT AND NOT SORT OF BE A
DETRIMENT. SO APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT THERE. LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING WHAT COMES OUT OF THAT,
THE ONLY ONE THAT I THINK HASN'T
BEEN DRILLED DOWN ON, AT LEAST
ON MY LIST, IS THIS, JUST THIS
THIS LINE BETWEEN THE WHERE THE
HUMAN DECISION CUTS OFF AND
WHERE, LIKE, THIS IS YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR
TEST, LIKE WHERE THE TOOL IS
MAKING THE DECISION VERSUS THE
PERSON'S MAKING THE DECISION. SO
I THOUGHT THIS HYPOTHETICAL
MIGHT HELP ME UNDERSTAND BETTER
WHERE THIS IS GOING. SO, SAY I,
RUN A BIG COMPANY AND I WANT TO
DO MORE WORK WITH WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES OR WOMEN AND MINORITY
OWNED BUSINESSES. AND I GO
SEARCH FOR THAT WITHIN WHATEVER
MY SALESFORCE CRM, AND I WANT TO
I SPECIFICALLY WANT TO CONTRACT
WITH THEM AND NOT NECESSARILY
WITH, ANY BUSINESS. AM I IS THAT
A IS THAT A HUMAN DECISION AT
THAT POINT, OR IS THAT THE TOOL
MAKING THAT DECISION? BECAUSE, I
MEAN, I'M I GUESS I'M SOMEWHAT
DISCRIMINATING AS THAT, AS THAT
BUSINESS OWNER TO SAY, YOU KNOW,
I WANT TO WORK WITH WOMEN AND
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES, AND
I'M INHERENTLY KIND OF EXCLUDING
OTHER BUSINESSES, TO SEE WHO IN
MY REGION DOES THAT KIND OF
WORK. SO HELP ME WITH THAT LINE.
LIKE, IS THAT ME? IS THAT ME AS
A HUMAN MAKING THAT DECISION? IS
THE OR IS THE TOOL THEN MAKING
THAT DECISION AND THEREFORE
WOULD THAT KIND OF SEARCH BE
BARRED? OKAY. SO NOTHING BARS
THIS. I MEAN WE TALK WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT CIVIL RIGHTS LAW
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT THE SUBJECT.
SO CIVIL RIGHTS LAW MIGHT DEAL
WITH THAT. BUT THAT'S NOT THE
SUBJECT OF TODAY'S CONVERSATION.
SO NOTHING WOULD BAR YOUR
SEARCH. RIGHT. SO AGAIN I WANT
TO REMEMBER THAT ALL WE'RE DOING
IS SAYING WHEN I BUILD THAT
TOOL, THAT CRM, I NEED TO TEST
IT TO MAKE SURE IF YOU PUT IN A
SEARCH, YOU'RE NOT, YOU KNOW, I
MEAN, AN EXAMPLE AND I'M GOING
TO GIVE AMAZON CREDIT, AMAZON
BUILT THEIR OWN HIRING TOOL.
THEY TESTED IT. IT WAS FOR, I
BELIEVE, ENGINEERS. THEY TESTED
IT. IT WAS TRAINED ON WHO THEIR
CURRENT POPULATION OF ENGINEERS
WERE, WHICH, NOT SURPRISING TO
ANYBODY ON THIS DAIS, WAS MOSTLY
MEN. SO IT THE TOOL LEARNED TO
SELECT MEN AND AMAZON CAUGHT
THAT AND DIDN'T DEPLOY IT.
RIGHT. I THINK THEY WERE PUBLIC
ABOUT IT IN FACT. AND THAT'S THE
KIND OF THING WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. THEY TESTED IT. THEY SAW
THAT IT WAS PICKING THE MEN
BECAUSE IT THOUGHT MEN WERE
BETTER ENGINEERS, BECAUSE THERE
WERE MORE MALE ENGINEERS. AND SO
THEY STOPPED IT. THEY DIDN'T
DEPLOY IT. YOU COULD THEN FIX
THAT. YOU COULD PROVIDE IT WITH
NEW DATA. YOU COULD MODIFY IT
AND RETEST IT AND DEPLOY IT. SO
I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT THE BILL DOES, AND, THE
SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR PIECE, WHAT
WE DON'T WANT, I MEAN, WHAT I
THINK WE'RE TRYING TO FIND THE
BALANCE, WHICH IS VERY HARD TO
DO IN LANGUAGE, IS WE DON'T WANT
SOMEONE WHO'S JUST PRESSING A
BUTTON AND NOW SAYING THE ADT
ISN'T MAKING THE DECISION,
RIGHT? BECAUSE NOW YOU HAVE A
HUMAN WHO'S GOING, BOOP, BOOP
BOOP, RIGHT. CLUE. THE ADT IS
MAKING THE DECISION. BUT WE ALSO
WANT THE LANDLORD THAT GETS THAT
CREDIT REPORT. AND THEY'RE
LOOKING AT THE CREDIT REPORT AND
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE OTHER
FACTORS. THE CREDIT REPORT ISN'T
MAKING THE DECISION RIGHT. THE
LANDLORD IS. SO THAT SHOULD NOT
BE INCLUDED. RIGHT. SO HOW WE
FIND THE DIFFERENCE, THE RIGHT
LANGUAGE IS STILL SOMETHING
WE'RE WORKING ON. BUT THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE. I
HOPE THAT WAS CLEAR. YEAH. CAN I
JUST ADD I DON'T THINK A
SALESFORCE DATABASE IS MAKING A
DECISION. JUST ASK IF THAT
ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION. ALMOST,
IF YOU LIKE. YEAH IF YOU DON'T
MIND THE INDULGENCE. I KNOW IT'S
A LONG HEARING. I JUST THE ISSUE
IS THAT THAT HYPOTHETICAL.
RIGHT. SO I GET THAT IT WOULDN'T
BAR THE USE OF THAT TOOL. BUT IN
YOU KNOW, IF YOUR SALES FORCE
AND YOU'RE DESIGNING YOUR TOOL
AND YOU'RE TESTING YOUR TOOL,
DOES THAT MEAN THAT THE TEST
WOULD SHOW UP, THAT, YOU KNOW,
THAT WOULD TRIGGER THIS, THIS
KIND OF, THAT WOULD TRIGGER
THAT, THAT ALGORITHMIC
DISCRIMINATION IF YOU, IF THE
TOOL WOULD ALLOW YOU SAY, TO
DISCRIMINATE OR DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN AND MAYBE THOSE ARE
SIMILAR WORDS DEPENDING ON HOW
AN ALGORITHM WORKS. BUT FROM A
MINORITY OR A WOMAN OWNED
BUSINESS TO OTHER BUSINESSES,
LIKE, COULD THEY NOT EVEN DESIGN
THAT INTO THE TOOL IN THE FIRST
PLACE? WELL, I DON'T BELIEVE A
SEARCH OF A SALESFORCE DATABASE
WOULD MEET THE DEFINITION OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AS
OUTLINED IN THIS BILL. I DON'T I
DON'T BELIEVE IT'S NOT MAKING
THE DECISION FOR YOU. IT'S
RESPONDING TO YOUR SEARCH, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT LIKE IF A LANDLORD
IS DOING A BACKGROUND CHECK AND
A TENANT SCREENING ALGORITHM
TELLS THEM THIS TENANT IS,
HOWEVER, LIKELY TO PAY RENT OR
NOT BASED ON TOTALLY OPAQUE AND
NONTRANSPARENT DATA THAT MAY BE
BIASED. NOW, THAT LANDLORD IS,
IS LIABLE FOR THAT DECISION AND
THAT LANDLORD DOESN'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO KNOW
WHETHER THEY ARE VIOLATING THAT
PERSON'S CIVIL RIGHTS OR NOT. SO
I THINK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TOOLS THAT MAKE DECISIONS AND
PRODUCE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
DECISIONS, NOT DATABASES THAT
HELP YOU SORT THROUGH DATA TO
MAKE YOUR OWN DECISION. BUT IF I
BUT IF I, YOU KNOW, IF I'M A
BUSINESS, IT'S NOT A MINORITY
WOMAN OWNED BUSINESS AND I WANT
AN ALTERNATE DECISION PROCESS,
THEN BECAUSE I KNOW THAT I COULD
BE, YOU KNOW, I COULD BE PUSHED
OUT OF THE SEARCHING, YOU KNOW,
I DON'T KNOW. WOULDN'T THEN A
BUNCH OF OTHER CLASS OF PEOPLE
BE ENTITLED TO IT? YEAH. SO I
THINK IF I UNDERSTAND THE
QUESTION, SENATOR, ONE OF THE
THINGS ACTUALLY, THAT CAME UP
IMMEDIATELY WITH DOCTOR WEBER
WHEN WE WROTE THIS BILL WAS SHE
SAID IN THE HEALTH CARE SETTING,
WE ACTUALLY NEED TOOLS THAT DO
QUOTE UNQUOTE, DISCRIMINATE,
BECAUSE SOMETIMES YOU HAVE A
POPULATION OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
DIFFERENT HEALTH CARE FACTORS.
FOR EXAMPLE. RIGHT? SO WE
ACTUALLY DO TREAT DIFFERENT
PEOPLE BASED ON SOMETIMES THEIR
RACE AND ETHNICITY DIFFERENTLY
IN A HEALTH CARE SETTING. RIGHT.
AND THAT'S SO THAT'S, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION THAT I
THINK IF THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING, BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
HARM PEOPLE WHEN THEY'RE TRYING
TO, THAT'S A BENEFIT. RIGHT? SO
THE QUESTION IS, IS IT CREATING
NEGATIVE BIAS. RIGHT. AND IF IT
IS RETEST IT AND FIX IT BEFORE
YOU DEPLOY IT AGAIN, I REALLY
THINK THAT THAT'S NOT A BURDEN
THAT YOU KNOW, FOLKS SHOULD.
OKAY, YEAH, I GUESS IT WOULD
JUST HELP TO WRAP THAT THREAD UP
AND THEN I'LL STOP. JUST TO KNOW
GOING FORWARD THAT LINE I GET
YOU HAVE THE SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR
TEST, BUT HOW, HOW AND DO YOU
ANTICIPATE REFINING IT? RIGHT.
THAT DISTINCTION GOING FORWARD.
DO YOU GUYS THINK IT'S GOOD AS
IS OR DO YOU ANTICIPATE FURTHER
REFINEMENTS OF THAT, THAT TEST
OF THE LINE BETWEEN HUMAN AND
TOOL MAKING DECISIONS? SO THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY SOMETHING WE'RE STILL
TALKING ABOUT OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR STERN. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS IS
THERE A MOTION SENATOR CAVALLERO
MOVES THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION. ALL RIGHTY. THANK
YOU, AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
MOVEMENT. AS I MENTIONED A
MOMENT AGO, MANY MOMENTS AGO,
THAT I ANTICIPATE FURTHER
MOVEMENTS. SO THANKS. ALL RIGHT.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM 63, AB
2930. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG UMBERG. I
WILK NÓ. WILK NÓ ALLEN. ASHBY
ASHBY. AYE. CABALLERO CABALLERO.
AYE. DURAZO. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE.
NILO NILO. NO. ROTH. ROTH. AYE
STERN. STERN. AYE. WAHAB YOU
HAVE 6 TO 2 WITH MEMBERS
MISSING. ALL RIGHT. SIX, TWO.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ. SO, BY THE WAY,
JUST TO I CONFESSED AIR TO
QUICKLY. SENATOR LAIRD, BECAUSE
IT WAS ONLY TEN HOURS. IT JUST
SEEMED TO YOU TO BE 11 HOURS.
CORRECT ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. WAY TO
RIGHT. THERE'S A GOOD. THAT WAS
A VERY GOOD SAVE. ALL RIGHT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ, AB
1472. OR YOU CAN DO 1597. YOU
WANT TO DO 1597. HE'S UP HERE
ALREADY, SO COME ON. MIGHT AS
WELL TRY TO MOVE YOU ALONG A
LITTLE MORE QUICKLY. THANK YOU
BOTH AT THE SAME TIME. SO OKAY,
THAT ALLOWED I DON'T KNOW IF THE
RULES ALLOW FOR THAT. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS WHO ARE
STILL WITH US HERE, APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 1597 AND WOULD
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, THIS BILL
REPRESENTS AN INNOVATIVE AND
SMART APPROACH TOWARDS
ADDRESSING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DISASTER THAT IS OCCURRING ON
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER, JUST FOR
CONTEXT, WE ARE NOW ROUGHLY AT
1000 DAYS SINCE THE BEACH AT
IMPERIAL BEACH HAS BEEN CLOSED
AND NOT ACCESSIBLE TO THE
RESIDENTS OF SOUTH SAN DIEGO,
ALL OF WHICH IS IN MY DISTRICT
FOR SEVERAL DECADES NOW, AND IN
FACT, FOR MY ENTIRE LIFETIME,
THE TIJUANA RIVER IN SAN DIEGO,
AND NOT JUST MY LIFETIME, BUT
MANY OTHERS LIFETIME. THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND NEW RIVER AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY HAVE EXPERIENCED
BILLIONS OF GALLONS OF UNTREATED
WASTEWATER, INDUSTRIAL TOXINS
AND SOLID WASTE AND SEDIMENT
FLOWING THROUGH THE WATERWAYS.
THESE TWO WATERSHEDS THAT SHARE
THAT ARE SHARED BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA, A STATE, AND MEXICO,
A COUNTRY, ARE FREQUENTLY RANKED
AS THE MOST CONTAMINATED
WATERWAYS IN THE UNITED STATES.
AB 1597 WOULD AUTHORIZE THE CAL
EPA TO ENTER INTO AGREEMENTS
WITH THE NORTH AMERICAN
DEVELOPMENT BANK FOR WATER
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS IN
THESE BINATIONAL WATERSHEDS. THE
NORTH AMERICAN DEVELOPMENT BANK,
KNOWN AS NAT'L BANK, IS A
FEDERAL INSTITUTION CREATED BY
NAFTA IN 1994 TO SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESS ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES AND
IMPLEMENT PROJECTS ALONG THE US
MEXICO BORDER. NEDBANK ALSO HAS
AGREEMENTS LIKE THESE WITH THE
STATES OF TEXAS AS AN EXAMPLE,
AND SINCE 1997, NEDBANK HAS
RECEIVED $711 MILLION OF PUBLIC
FUNDING, WHICH THEY'VE LEVERAGED
FOR A TOTAL INVESTMENT OF $11.5
BILLION ON ENVIRONMENTAL
PROJECTS, SPECIFICALLY ALONG THE
BORDER. THAT IS A 1 TO 15 PUBLIC
CAPITAL INVESTMENT RATIO. AB
1597 WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO
BE A PARTNER IN THOSE EFFORTS,
I'VE INCLUDED SEVERAL AMENDMENTS
THAT STRENGTHEN ENFORCEMENT FOR
THE STATE, AND I ALSO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS LISTED IN
THE ANALYSIS. THE BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY A VERY LARGE
COALITION OF PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS, HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND ZERO NO VOTES,
I'D LIKE TO TURN IT OVER NOW TO
OUR PRIMARY WITNESS. GOOD
EVENING, MISTER CHAIR. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, JONATHAN CLAY HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO
IN SUPPORT, I'LL JUST KEEP THIS
SHORT, BUILDING ON WHAT? THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID, I'M
LITERALLY THE SECOND GENERATION
TO WORK ON THIS TIJUANA RIVER
PROBLEM AS A REGION, SAN DIEGO
HAS ALWAYS COME TOGETHER TO TRY
AND ADDRESS THESE ISSUES,
LEGISLATION FROM A FEW YEARS
BACK, SB 507 FROM SENATOR HUESO
WAS AN IN-DEPTH STUDY TO LOOK AT
ALL THE DIFFERENT PROJECTS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER THAT
COULD BE USED TO HELP ADDRESS
THIS. BEING ABLE TO UTILIZE THE
ABILITY OF THE NAT BANK TO BE
ABLE TO DO PROJECTS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE BORDER THROUGH THE
INTERNATIONAL BOUNDARY AND WATER
COMMISSION, WILL BE EXTREMELY
HELPFUL IN TRYING TO GET AT SOME
OF THESE PROJECTS, NAT BANK IS
SOMETHING THAT AT LEAST THOSE OF
US IN SAN DIEGO ARE VERY AWARE
OF AND IS A TRUSTED ENTITY. SAME
WITH IBWC. AND THERE ARE SOME
INNOVATIVE THINGS THAT THOSE
ENTITIES, ALONG WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN SAN DIEGO, ARE
EXPLORING TO TRY AND DO THINGS
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER WITH
THAT, WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU,
KARA ROSS, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF CORONADO, JUST VERY QUICKLY
THIS EVENING, STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL. WE'RE VERY THANKFUL
FOR THE AUTHOR'S EFFORTS ON
THIS. CORONADO IS ONE OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAS CONTINUED
TO SEE CROSS BORDER POLLUTION
AND SEE OUR BEACHES CLOSED
AGAIN, AND AGAIN. SO WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL, AND I'LL
JUST ALSO NOTE THAT WE'VE I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO VOICE SUPPORT FROM
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES,
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
, ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES, AND
THE RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB 1597,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR EVENING? I'M
BRENDA BASS WITH CPW PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE. LET'S
TALK TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 1597,
PLEASE APPROACH. SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHING, LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, WHAT QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS DO YOU HAVE? SENATOR
ALSO WISHES TO MAKE A MOTION.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. SENATOR RUSSO HAS MOVED
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT, FIRST,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALVAREZ. YOU'VE
WORKED VERY HARD ON THIS BILL. I
APPRECIATE YOU ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS, SO HAVING SAID THAT,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND I APPRECIATE
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM 66, AB
1597. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG Ã
UMBERG. AYE. WILK ALLEN. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE CABALLERO. DURAZO Dð.
RUSSELL. AYE. LAIRD LAIRD. AYE.
NILO. NILO. AYE ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
STERN WAHAB 6060. WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALVAREZ, NEXT,
BILL, AB 1472. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. I'LL TRY TO WORK THROUGH
THIS ONE BRIEFLY AS WELL.
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB 1472 FOR THOSE WHO,
ARE RETURNING MEMBERS TO THIS
COMMITTEE MIGHT REMEMBER THIS
BILL WAS GRANTED
RECONSIDERATION, IN WHICH,
AGAIN, I THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
THE WORK ON THIS. ASSEMBLY. BILL
1472 ADDRESSES THE UNFAIR
BUSINESS PRACTICE KNOWN AS THE
RV SHUFFLE, WHICH INVOLVES
EVICTING AND RELOCATING TENANTS
IN THEIR RVS FROM AN AUTHORIZED
RV PARK, USUALLY FOR A PERIOD OF
48 HOURS EVERY SEVERAL MONTHS.
TO AVOID TENANTS GAINING
RESIDENCY STATUS, CERTAIN
TENANCY STATUS THAT WOULD
PROVIDE THEM FROM SUBSTANTIVE
TENANT PROTECTIONS. THIS
PRACTICE IS IMPACTING THE
CONSTITUENTS OF MY COMMUNITY OF
IMPERIAL BEACH, MANY OF WHOM ARE
ELDERLY ADULTS ON FIXED INCOME
SPANISH SPEAKERS WHO HAVE
RESORTED TO RV LIVING, IN PART
DUE TO THE COST OF LIVING AND
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA. MANY OF
THE INDIVIDUALS HAVE LIVED IN
THE PARK FOR MANY YEARS, TEN
YEARS OR LONGER, AND HAVE BEEN
THREATENED WITH PERMANENT
EVICTION IF THEY DO NOT COMPLY
WITH THE RV SHUFFLE. IN 2004,
THE STATE LEGISLATURE ENACTED AB
2867 TO DISCOURAGE SIMILAR
PRACTICE THAT IS OCCURRING IN
RESIDENTIAL HOTELS. AB 1472
ENSURES THAT RESIDENTS ARE
LIVING WITHOUT THE FEAR AND
INTIMIDATION OF BEING FORCED TO
FREQUENTLY RELOCATE. SINCE LAST
YEAR, WE TOOK CONCERNS THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP BY THIS COMMITTEE.
VERY, VERY SPECIFIC CONCERNS
ASKED ME TO COME BACK AND MAKE
THIS A DISTRICT BILL AS I HAD
INITIATED BEFORE COMING OVER TO
THE SENATE, SO THAT THIS WOULD
ONLY APPLY TO THE CITY OF
IMPERIAL BEACH. WE HAVE DONE
THAT. THE AMENDED BILL IS
SUPPORTED STILL BY THE CITY OF
IMPERIAL BEACH, WHO INITIALLY
ENACTED A TEMPORARY MORATORIUM
TO PROVIDE RESIDENTS WITH SOME
PROTECTION AND RELIEF. BUT SINCE
SPECIAL OCCUPANCY OCCUPANCY
PARKS FALL UNDER THE STATE'S
JURISDICTION, STATE LEGISLATION
IS REQUIRED TO EXTEND THAT
PROTECTION BEYOND WHAT THE CITY
HAS ALREADY DONE, SO AT A TIME
WHEN CALIFORNIA IS IN DIRE NEED
OF ALL TYPES OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, WE SHOULD NOT BE
EVICTING RESIDENTS WHO HAVE
FOUND SUITABLE SHELTER AND ARE
ABLE TO ABIDE BY ALL OTHER
RULES, INCLUDING PAYING THEIR
MONTHLY RENT. AND FOR THAT
REASON, I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS
RECONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT,
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
1472, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE, SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHING. LET'S TALK TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 1472, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU. PLEASURE TO SEE YOU
ALL AGAIN. EVEN THIS LATE HOUR.
I'LL MAKE IT QUICK. I'VE GOT TO
GRAB THE MICROPHONE. THERE WE
GO. THANK YOU. THERE WE GO.
DIANA KELLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
OUTDOOR HOSPITALITY ASSOCIATION.
WE RESPECTFULLY CONTINUE TO
OPPOSE AB 1472 ON THE GROUNDS
THAT IT IS UNNECESSARY,
UNWARRANTED, AND IT SETS A
PRECEDENCE THAT COULD HAVE A
DETRIMENTAL IMPACT ON FUTURE RV
PARKS. AB 1472 TARGETS A MOBILE
HOME PARK WITH 77 RV SPACES AND
ANY NEW PARKS THAT ARE GOING TO
BE BUILT WITHIN THOSE CITY
LIMITS. IT WILL ACTUALLY HAVE
THE OPPOSITE EFFECT OF WHAT THE
BILL IS TRYING TO ACHIEVE. THE
TRIGGER HERE IS FOR THIS
LEGISLATION IS WHEN A TENANT
WANTS TO RETURN TO THE PARK.
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE BILL THAT
PROVIDES FOR A SET PERIOD OF
VACANCY BEFORE A RETURN, SO
THERE WILL BE NO OPTION FOR A
GUEST TO COME BACK TO THE PARK
AT ANY TIME IN THE FUTURE
WITHOUT POTENTIAL DETRIMENT TO
THE PARK OWNER. FURTHERMORE,
UNLESS AMENDED, THIS LEGISLATION
STILL APPLIES TO AN OCCUPANT,
TENANT, OR RESIDENT, MAKING IT
MORE CONFUSING THAT WHAT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN CHANGED LAST YEAR, A
VACATIONER WANTING TO RETURN TO
A NEW PARK WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
WITHOUT THE OWNER BEING SUBJECT
TO FINES. BASED ON THIS
LEGISLATION AND LASTLY, NEW
INFORMATION HAS COME TO LIGHT
RECENTLY THAT THE PARK IN
QUESTION HAS ABANDONED ITS
DESIRE TO BECOME A TRANSIENT
PARK AND NOW ONLY OFFERS LONG
TERM EXTENDED STAYS, I CONFIRM
THIS PRACTICE TODAY BY ACTUALLY
DOING A SECRET SHOPPER ON THE
PARK AND WAS ABLE TO CONFIRM
THAT INFORMATION. THE PARK OWNER
SETTLED INTO AN AGREEMENT WITH
THE CITY, AND THEY AGREED THAT
IF HE MOVED TO A LONG TERM PARK,
THEY WOULD RELEASE THEIR
MORATORIUM. THAT MORATORIUM HAS
BEEN BEEN RELEASED, AND THE CITY
HAS AGREED. WE HAVE
DOCUMENTATION BOTH IN EMAIL AND
LETTER FORMAT TO PROVE THAT, WE
BELIEVE AT THIS TIME THAT
THERE'S JUST NO LONGER A NEED
FOR THIS LEGISLATION. AND WE ARE
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU.
WOW. 157 VERY PRESENT. ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE ROOM THAT WANTS TO
ADD ME TO TESTIMONY, SEEING NONE
? BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE, SENATOR LAIRD, MR.
CHAIR, LAST YEAR WE CONSIDERED
THIS BILL TWICE, AND EACH TIME
WE SAID HE NEEDED TO NARROW IT
TO A DISTRICT BILL. HE HAS DONE
IT. I MOVED THE BILL. THANK YOU
FOR THAT. ANYBODY ELSE? NO.
SEEING WE HAVE A MOTION. YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU. AS WAS STATED
BY SENATOR LAIRD, THIS COMMITTEE
GAVE US DIRECTION ON WHAT TO DO.
WE HAVE DONE THAT, AND WE BRING
THAT BILL TO YOU TODAY. AND I'D
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE,
VOTE. THE MOVE THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU. WITH THAT SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLE. THIS IS
FINAL ITEM 65 AB 1472. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG WILK NOT
VOTING. ALLEN ASHBY. CABALLERO.
DURAZO DURAZO. AYE. LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE NEELO. NO. MILLER. NO
ROTH. ROTH. AYE STERN. WAHAB 3
TO 1. OKAY. CURRENT VOTES 3 TO
1. WE WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. PLENTY OF
COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE YET TO VOTE
. I MEAN, I THINK IT'S. SO
ASSEMBLYWOMAN AGUIAR-CURRY, NOW,
YOU KNOW HOW NOW? NOW YOU KNOW
THE PAIN THAT SENATOR UMBERG AND
I FEEL EVERY WEEK. I'M SO
TEMPTED TO MOVE TO ADJOURN.
OKAY. WE HAVE A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. NON-DEBATABLE YOU KNOW,
THAT'S ALMOST FUNNY. AND, YOU
KNOW WHAT'S EVEN FUNNIER? MY
BEGINNING. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS. FIRST, I'D LIKE TO SAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR STICKING
THIS OUT. I MEAN, I CAN'T
IMAGINE HAVING TO GO THROUGH
THIS MANY BILLS. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND THANK YOU FOR THE
PEOPLE OF OUR CONSTITUENTS FOR
ALL THE GOOD WORK YOU'RE DOING,
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR THE WORK ON THIS BILL.
I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF FOR
THE PURPOSES OF THIS HEARING,
BUT I'M PREPARED TO HAVE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS SINCE JULY
2011, CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS HAVE
PAID A CARPET STEWARDSHIP
ASSESSMENT FEE WHEN PURCHASING
CARPETS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
THESE FEES Ã THESE FEES FUND A
STATEWIDE CARPET RECYCLING
PROGRAM KNOWN AS THE CARPET
AMERICA RECOVERY EFFORT, ALSO
KNOWN AS CARE, WHICH IS A
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
ORGANIZATION DESIGNED AND
IMPLEMENTED BY CARPET
MANUFACTURERS WITH CALRECYCLE
OVERSIGHT FOR MAJOR PROCESSORS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE NO LONGER IN
OPERATION, IN PART BECAUSE WE
NEED TO IMPROVE MANAGEMENT OF
OUR SYSTEM. ONE OF THOSE CLOSED
DOWN IN MY DISTRICT, OPPONENTS
HERE TODAY WILL SAY THAT THEIR
RECYCLING RATES ARE GOING UP AND
THAT THEY ARE MEETING THEIR
GOALS, BUT CARE'S CURRENT CLAIMS
OF SUCCESS ARE BASED ON RECOVERY
RATE THAT COMPARES THE CARPET
RECYCLED TO DECLINING CARPET
SALES. THIS INFLATES THE
RECOVERY NUMBERS AND POORLY
DEPICTS HOW THE CURRENT MARKET
SHIFT TO OTHER TYPES OF FLOORING
IS REALLY AFFECTING THE CARPET
RECYCLING PROGRAM. I'VE SPENT
OVER TWO YEARS LEARNING ABOUT
THE STATE OF THE CURRENT CARPET
RECYCLING PROGRAM, AND WHERE
DIFFERENT FLOORING ENTITIES ARE
AT WITH RECYCLING EFFORTS. MY
STAFF HAS HAVE DOZENS OF
MEETINGS WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN
THAT TIME, INCLUDING DOUBLE
DIGIT MEETINGS WITH CARE AND ITS
REPRESENTATIVES. AS A RESULT, I
HAVE DECIDED TO REMOVE THE
SYNTHETIC TURF FROM THE BILL AND
WILL CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT TURF NEXT YEAR. SHOULD
THIS BILL MAKE IT OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY, I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
COMMITTEE. I'VE AMENDED THE AB
863 TO WHAT I CAN CONFIDENTLY
PROPOSE AS A FIX TO THE WAY THE
CARPET RECYCLING PROGRAM IS RUN
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS HEIDI SANBORN,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL. AND VAL, WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PARTNERS
AND ALLIED TRADES DISTRICT
COUNCIL. SIX WELCOME, AND EACH
OF YOU GET TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS I'M HEIDI SANBORN
WITH THE NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP
ACTION COUNCIL, THE SPONSOR OF
THE BILL. AND WE'RE HERE TO FIX
THE PROBLEMS WITH THE EXISTING
CARPET RECYCLING PROGRAM AND
ADDRESS THE NEW PRODUCTS THAT
ARE ENTERING THE MARKET AND
INCREASING IN MARKET SHARE,
TAKING AWAY FROM THE CARPET
SALES THAT HAVE NO RECYCLING
SYSTEM IN PLACE CURRENTLY AND
THEREFORE, WE'RE GOING TO
ESTABLISH A MORE FAIR AND LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD IN THE FLOORING
CATEGORY. THE TOP FIVE REASONS
THAT WE NEED THIS BILL NOW IS
THAT THE COLLECTORS, NUMBER ONE,
ARE NOT GETTING PAID IN THIS
PROGRAM. IF YOU RECYCLE TO
COLLECT CARPET, YOU DON'T GET
PAID FOR THE LABOR TO DO THAT
LIKE YOU DO IN THE MATTRESS
PROGRAM. THAT'S WHY THE
CONSERVATION CAUSE TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. BECAUSE
THEY HAVE ONE CONSERVATION CORPS
COLLECTING, AND THEY WILL NOT DO
IT IN THE OTHER. 13 CAUSE
RECYCLERS. WE HAVE FOUR THAT
REMAIN. ONE OF THOSE FOUR IS
GETTING MORE THAN 50% OF THE
CARPET. THE OTHER THREE ARE
SPLITTING THE REST, AND THEY ARE
NOT GETTING ENOUGH. THEY'RE
POACHING EACH OTHER'S CARPET
SUPPLY BECAUSE MORE THAN 50% IS
STILL ENDING UP IN THE LANDFILL.
14 YEARS AFTER THIS PROGRAM
STARTED. THREE IS THAT WE'RE
FAILING TO MEET THE GOALS, AND
WE HAVE A CONSISTENT ENFORCEMENT
PROBLEM. AS LATE AS JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR, CAL RECYCLE FOUND
THAT THE 2022 ANNUAL REPORT WAS
NOT COMPLIANT, AND THEY WERE
FINED $1.2 MILLION IN PENALTIES
IN 2022 FOR MULTIPLE FAILURES OF
THE PROGRAM. FOUR IS FUNDING.
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH MONEY, THE
SALES ARE DROPPING AND THE FEE
CONTINUES TO GO UP. BUT THE
FUNDING IS DROPPING AND THAT'S A
PROBLEM. AND FIVE IS MARKET
DEVELOPMENT. WE REALLY NEED MORE
CARPET TO BE RECYCLED INTO
CARPET RIGHT NOW. THE CARPET
INDUSTRY IS USING CLEAN FOOD
GRADE WATER BOTTLES TO MAKE
RECYCLED CONTENT AND CARPET. BUT
IF WE HAD CARPET TO CARPET, WE'D
HAVE A MARKET AND THE BOTTLERS
WOULD BE MUCH HAPPIER. IN FACT,
I BELIEVE SEVERAL OF THEM ARE
HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. SO WHAT THE BILL DOES
FOR COLLECTORS IS WE'RE GOING TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE GOING TO THE
EPR PROGRAM WILL HAVE TO PAY THE
COLLECTORS. SO FINALLY, WE'LL
HAVE MORE COLLECTION LOCATIONS
AND MAKE IT MORE CONVENIENT FOR
CONSUMERS AND FREE DROP OFF. WE
SHOULDN'T BE CHARGING A FEE WHEN
THEY BUY IT. AND THEN A FEE WHEN
THEY DISPOSE. IT SHOULD BE ALL
BE UP FRONT. THE RECYCLERS WILL
GET THE CARPET THAT THEY NEED.
WE'VE GOT MANDATORY SORTING IN
THE BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
GET THE CARPET AND WE'LL HAVE
MORE COLLECTION LOCATIONS SO
THAT IT CAN GET TO THEM. THREE
IS THE OVERSIGHT. AGAIN, WE'RE
GOING TO SOLVE THAT. WE'VE GOT
INCREASED PENALTIES. WE DID NOT
DOUBLE IT LIKE WE HAD WANTED TO
GO TO 50,000. WE DID 25 BECAUSE
THEY SAID OPPOSITION WANTED
THAT. AND WE AGREED WE WANT TO
REVISIT THE RECYCLING RATE IN
THE FORMULA, AS WE SAID, AND
FUNDING. WE'RE GOING TO ADD
CARPET PAD. THEY'RE ALREADY
COLLECTING IT, BUT THEY'RE NOT
GETTING FUNDING FOR IT. SO THIS
WILL HELP FUND THE PROGRAM. AND
THEN LASTLY MARKET DEVELOPMENT.
AGAIN, WE REALLY NEED TO GET THE
CLEAN FOOD GRADE WATER BOTTLES
OUT OF CARPET AND INTO BOTTLES.
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. WE'RE
NOT PAYING ATTENTION. YOU ARE
WAY WAY WAY. OH DID I I'M SORRY.
CONGRATULATIONS TO MY COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE HITTING THE 12TH HOUR.
IT'S OKAY. SHE WAS A NAMED
PERSON OF THE YEAR BY THE
CARMICHAEL CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THIS YEAR. AND THE PARADE ON
THE. I'LL BE QUICK. YOU KNOW
WHAT? WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE IN
THE PARADE BECAUSE WE'RE GOING
TO BE UP HERE. PROBABLY. YES,
SIR. HELLO, COMMITTEE. MY NAME
IS VAL CASTRO, AND I REPRESENT
DISTRICT COUNCIL 16, THE IUPAT,
I MY REGION IS NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA, AND THE STATE OF
NEVADA, I HAVE BEEN IN THIS
INDUSTRY FOR 39 YEARS. 18 OF
THAT AS A, INSTRUCTOR, I'M HERE
TODAY TO SEE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS IN REGARDS TO, THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE INSTALLATION
OF THE CARPET THAT IS TO BE
RECYCLED, THE TRAINING, OF, ANY
ASPECTS OF IT THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ASK QUESTIONS ON AND HOW
WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR
APPRENTICES, AND THEN, ALSO WITH
CARE, WE DID WORK WITH CARE. WE
TRY WE TRIED TO WORK WITH CARE,
THEY WERE UNABLE TO FULFILL A
LOT OF THEIR, COMMITMENTS THAT
THEY HAD MADE TO US. THEY DID
NOT HONOR WHAT THEY SAID THAT
THEY WOULD DO, SO NOW, WE'RE
ALMOST AT A STANDSTILL, WITH
WORKING WITH CARE. OKAY, GREAT,
WITH THAT, ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
ROOM THAT WANTS TO ADD ME TO
TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT, PLEASE
LINE UP, MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, MIKE WEST, ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR CHRIS MICHELI, ON
BEHALF OF NIAGARA BOTTLING
SUPPORT AND MY COLLEAGUE ELOY
GARCIA ASKED ME TO CONVEY HIS
CLIENT IBWA THE INTERNATIONAL
BOTTLED WATER ASSOCIATION ALSO
SUPPORTS IT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, JORDAN WELLS EXPRESSING
SUPPORT FOR THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS AQUAFIL CIRCULAR
POLYMERS, ZERO WASTE, SONOMA
CALPIRG, MARIN SANITARY SERVICE,
MOJAVE DESERT AND MOUNTAIN
RECYCLING AUTHORITY, SACRAMENTO
SPLASH, RUSSIAN HILL, NEIGHBORS
RISE BUILDING SOLUTIONS,
NATIONAL WASTE RECOVERY,
BROADVIEW GROUP, ARIZONA,
ALTERNATIVE MATERIALS, APEX
MANUFACTURING, RETAIL
CORPORATION, TRANSPORT TECH
LOGISTICS, CLOVER PLASTICS,
CIRCULAR STRATEGY, BETTER IMAGE
RECYCLING. SEA HUGGER PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP INSTITUTE. REPURPOSE
EARTH'S CRYSTAL MATERIALS.
FRANKFORT PLASTICS AND HERBAL
MEXICHEM. I'M NOT SURE HOW TO
SAY THAT. THANK YOU. OOPS,
SORRY. CLIFTON WILSON ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS, AS WELL AS STOP
WASTE WESTERN PLACER WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY, THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL, SOLID WASTE ASSOCIATION
OF NORTH AMERICA LEGISLATIVE
TASK FORCE, CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS
ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. BEAR WITH ME. I'VE GOT
VERTIGO AND I'M LIKE HOLDING ON
TO SOMETHING JUST TO STAND
HORRIBLE THING TO HAVE IT. IT'S
TERRIBLE. IT'S TERRIBLE, MY NAME
IS ROBERT SMITH. I'M WITH THE
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
DISTRICT COUNCIL, 36 SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA, ARIZONA AND NEW
MEXICO. AND WE STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO PASS THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SIR. HERE COMES OUR
CLOSER, BOB DREW, ON BEHALF OF
THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES, ON
BEHALF OF PRESIDENT JAMES C
WILLIAMS JR, WE WOULD LIKE OUR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS TO BE
ABLE TO INSTALL THIS RIGHT,
CORRECTLY. CURRENTLY, THERE ARE
60% OF ALL CARPET THAT IS
INSTALLED DOES NOT GET RECYCLED
BECAUSE IT'S BECAUSE OF THE
EPOXIES AND THE ADHESIVES THAT
ARE USED, WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL WILL ARRIVE AT THE RIGHT
SOLUTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. Þ. YOU WANT TO. OH,
NO, YOU'RE NOT HERE TO ME TO
SUPPORT. WELL, THEN COME TAKE A
SEAT UP FRONT. SO IT LOOKS LIKE
WE HAVE TWO SPEAKERS, EACH OF
YOU GENTLEMEN GET TWO MINUTES.
WHO'S GOING TO GO FIRST? THANK
YOU, MR. VICE CHAIR RANDY
POLLOCK, ON BEHALF OF THE CARPET
AND RUG INSTITUTE, WE'RE A
MEMBER OF THE CARE STEWARDSHIP
PLAN. AND I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT HOW FAR
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
OVER THE LAST TEN AND 12 YEARS.
NOW, THE PROPONENTS MENTIONED A
COUPLE PROBLEMS WITH OUR
PROGRAM. THE ONE THING I JUST
WANT TO CORRECT INITIALLY, MISS
SANBORN HAD MENTIONED THAT WE
HAD BEEN FINED FOR 2022, 1.5
MILLION OR 1.2 MILLION. THAT WAS
ACTUALLY FOR 2020 DURING COVID,
ALL OF OUR BUSINESSES WERE
CLOSED BY AN EXECUTIVE ORDER,
BUT WE WERE STILL HELD IN
NONCOMPLIANCE FOR NOT HAVING OUR
BUSINESSES OPEN. SO I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT. ADDITIONALLY,
WHEN WE DEAL WITH FACTS, LET'S
LOOK WHERE WE ARE TODAY. IN
2022, WE MET NINE OUT OF TEN
GOALS, AND WE MISSED THE OTHER
ONE BY JUST A FEW PERCENTAGE
POINTS, 2023 WE MET 12 OUT OF 13
GOALS. WE CONTINUE TO INCREASE
OUR COLLECTION SITES. WE HAVE
OVER 350 COLLECTION SITES. WE
KEEP ADDING THEM EVERY DAY. SO
THE PROGRAM IS WORKING. OUR
RECYCLING RATE CONTINUES TO
INCREASE FOR THE FIRST QUARTER
OF 2024, WE'RE AT 41. OUR GOAL
FOR THIS YEAR IS 34. SO THIS
PROGRAM IS WORKING. IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR BUSINESSES WHERE
YOU START CHANGING THE RULES OF
THE GAME, BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE A PLAN THAT'S BEEN APPROVED
BY CALRECYCLE, WHICH WAS
APPROVED OF APRIL OF 2023. WE
ARE ADHERING TO THOSE GOALS AND
MANY OF THEM WE ARE EXCEEDING.
SO NOW PEOPLE ARE COMING BACK
AND SAYING, WELL, YOU WANT TO
KNOW SOMETHING? WE REALLY DON'T
LIKE THE GOALS THAT HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY CALRECYCLE, AND
WE'RE GOING TO CHANGE THEM ON
YOU. WE DON'T THINK THAT'S FAIR.
WE BELIEVE THERE ARE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE PROGRAM.
ABSOLUTELY. WE'RE MORE THAN
WILLING TO SIT DOWN, BUT WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT DISMANTLES
THE WHOLE PROGRAM. IT CREATES A
PRO. SO WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO DO
HERE IS YOU'RE GOING TO
INVALIDATE HUNDREDS OF
CONTRACTS. ALL THE COLLECTION
SITES ARE GOING TO GO AWAY AND
GOING TO HAVE TO START NEW. THE
PROCESSORS AREN'T GOING TO QUITE
SURE WHETHER THEY'RE GOING TO
GET THE CARPET. SO WE'RE SAYING,
WHY WOULD WE GO TO A PROGRAM
LIKE THAT WHEN WE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE CURRENT
STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM? AND FOR AND
ONE LAST THING I'LL MENTION FOR
THE UNIONS. THERE WE HAVE DONE
OVER 200 TRAININGS OF
APPRENTICES. WE HAVE PROVIDED
TRAILERS TO THE UNIONS. WE HAVE
WEBSITES, WE HAVE MATERIALS IN
BOTH ENGLISH AND SPANISH. CARE
IS AVAILABLE 24 SEVEN TO GO OUT
TO THEIR FACILITY AND TO DO
TRAINING FOR THOSE REASONS, WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
EVENING, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS.
ANTHONY SAMSON HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE RESILIENT FLOOR COVERINGS
INSTITUTE, RFCI IS A TRADE
ASSOCIATION COMPRISED OF
RESILIENT FLOOR COVERING
PRODUCERS THAT MANUFACTURE VINYL
COMPOSITION TILE, LUXURY TILE,
SOLID VINYL, TILE, SHEET, VINYL
TILE, RUBBER TILE, SHEET,
RUBBER, LINOLEUM, AND OTHER
TYPES OF RESILIENT FLOORING. LET
ME FIRST START BY THANKING THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, HER STAFF AND
HER SPONSOR FOR REACHING OUT TO
RFCI AFTER THE BILL WAS
INTRODUCED AND FOR MEETING WITH
US. SINCE THAT TIME, OUR RFCI
UNDERSTANDS AND APPRECIATES THE
IMPORTANCE OF CONDUCTING A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT BEFORE ESTABLISHING
AN END OF LIFE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM. BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KEEP IN MIND THAT RESILIENT
FLOORING ENCOMPASSES SEVERAL
TYPES OF FLOORING PRODUCTS WITH
A BROAD RANGE OF PHYSICAL
PROPERTIES AND APPLICATIONS.
INDEED, DIFFERENT TYPES OF
RESILIENT FLOORING FACE
DIFFERENT AND DISTINCT
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF TECHNICAL
AND INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
ASSOCIATED WITH RECYCLING. FOR
THIS REASON, AS WE'VE DISCUSSED
WITH THE AUTHOR, HER STAFF AND
SPONSOR, WE BELIEVE THAT UPON
COMPLETION OF A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT, CALRECYCLE SHOULD
INSTEAD ISSUE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINING WHETHER
AN END OF LIFE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM FOR RESILIENT FLOORING
IS VIABLE, AND IF SO, CALRECYCLE
WOULD ISSUE RECOMMENDATIONS AS
TO HOW TO ESTABLISH AN END OF
LIFE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM FOR
RESILIENT FLOORING. RFCI WOULD
STAND READY AT THAT TIME TO WORK
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY IN THIS COMMITTEE
THROUGH THE COURSE OF A FULL
LEGISLATIVE SESSION, TO
ESTABLISH A PROGRAM THAT WORKS
FOR MANUFACTURERS, CONSUMERS,
RECYCLERS AND OTHER ENTITIES
THROUGHOUT THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
RFCI AND ITS MEMBERS HAVE
DECADES OF EXPERIENCE AND
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE IN THIS
AREA, AND ESTABLISHING A NEW
PROGRAM OF THIS MAGNITUDE ON A
NEW PRODUCT CATEGORY WILL
REQUIRE EXTENSIVE DIALOG BETWEEN
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND OUR
TECHNICAL EXPERTS, WHICH IS A
DIALOG WE ARE OPEN TO HAVING
AFTER THE COMPLETION OF A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. THANKS FOR
CONSIDERING OUR COMMENTS. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
DIALOG WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND THIS COMMITTEE. VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU FOR THAT TESTIMONY.
AND DO WE HAVE ANY, ME TOO.
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION. HI, MEG
SNYDER, AXIOM ADVISORS, ON
BEHALF OF BOTH THE VINYL
INSTITUTE AND THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION,
OPPOSED THANK YOU, JOHN MOFFITT,
ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
AUTOMOTIVE INNOVATION AND SHORE
INDUSTRIES, OPPOSED GREG HERNER
ON BEHALF OF THE SYNTHETIC TURF
COUNCIL, AS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED, SHE'S GOING TO BE
REMOVING US FROM THE BILL AND AT
THAT TIME WILL BE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION AS WELL. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. OKAY. BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS? CONCERNS. YEAH.
SENATOR CABALLERO, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR. WELL, I
HATE GUTTING AMENDS. SO LET ME
JUST SAY THAT. BUT, I KNOW THIS
AUTHOR, SHE DOES VERY, VERY GOOD
WORK. AND ALTHOUGH I THINK IT
NEEDS A THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
STILL TO BE DONE. I'M GOING TO
GIVE YOU A COURTESY VOTE TODAY,
AND I'LL MOVE THE BILL WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE, WE GOT TO GET THIS
RIGHT, AND IT'S GOT TO WORK FOR
EVERYBODY. AND I'D LIKE TO SEE
US GET TO A POINT WHERE
EVERYBODY'S OFF AND FEELING LIKE
IT'S GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. SO, ENOUGH SAID.
THANK YOU. THANK GOODNESS,
SENATOR ALLEN, I'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR YOU, IT'S BEEN A LONG, LONG
DAY, NO. AND YOU'RE MAKING IT
LONGER? YES. WELL, I, I, I ALL I
WILL SAY IS, THAT, YOU KNOW,
WELL, WHAT I, WHAT I WILL SAY IS
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE
THIS SUMMER. I AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS FROM SENATOR CABALLERO,
YOU KNOW, I DO HOLD, YOU KNOW,
THE WORK OF THE NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL IN
HIGH ESTEEM, AND I THINK THERE'S
A REAL PATH HERE, YOU KNOW, I
WILL SAY THAT DURING THE SB 54
NEGOTIATIONS, THE CARPET PROGRAM
WAS BROUGHT UP REPEATEDLY AS YOU
KNOW WHAT, WE DIDN'T WHAT WE
WANTED TO AVOID, YOU KNOW, THE
MISTAKES WE DIDN'T WANT TO MAKE,
AS WE CRAFTED SB 54. SO, WORK
HAS TO HAPPEN HERE. NOW, THE
QUESTION IS, IS IT GOING TO
HAPPEN THIS YEAR? IS IT GOING TO
OR IS IT GOING TO, YOU KNOW, END
UP BEING A NEXT YEAR? BILL. AND
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE
ULTIMATELY UP TO EVERYONE
SITTING BEFORE US, YOU KNOW,
EVERY EPR BILL IS DIFFERENT. YOU
CAN'T JUST SPLOTCH DOWN AN EPR
MODEL ONTO A NEW PRODUCT WITHOUT
REALLY GOING THROUGH ALL THE
DETAILS OF THE INDUSTRY SUPPLY
CHAIN, THE MECHANICS, THE
LOGISTICS, THE WORKFORCE ISSUES,
YOU KNOW, IT'S COMPLICATED. IT'S
REALLY COMPLICATED. AND SO I'M
JUST HOPEFUL THAT WITH THE VERY
TALENTED PEOPLE HERE, BOTH AT
THE, AT THE DÍAS AND ALSO THE
FOLKS WHO HAVE SPOKEN, THAT YOU
CAN COME TO SOME, YOU KNOW,
STRONG SOLUTION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, I KNOW IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE EASY. AND QUITE
FRANKLY, I HAVE NO IDEA WHETHER
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF THESE BILLS,
WE KIND OF HAVE A GOOD SENSE OF
WHETHER IT'S GOING TO SUCCEED OR
NOT. I JUST DON'T KNOW, BUT I'M
OBVIOUSLY FOLLOWING IT VERY
CLOSELY. AS SOMEONE WHO CARES A
GREAT DEAL ABOUT EPR PROGRAMS,
WHO CARES A LOT A GREAT DEAL
ABOUT, ABOUT ABOUT ABOUT THIS
MODEL. AND SO I'M JUST HOPEFUL
AND I WISH YOU ALL GODSPEED. I
KNOW IT'S GOING TO RUIN YOUR
VACATIONS, BUT I'M CERTAINLY,
YOU KNOW, GOING TO GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. BUT, I
THINK WE HAVE TO GO IN, YOU
KNOW, SOBER EYED ABOUT THE
PROSPECTS AND REALLY HOPE THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO STRIKE A GOOD DEAL
HERE THAT'S GOING TO GOING TO
ADDRESS THE VERY REAL ISSUES
THAT THE BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS.
OKAY. THANK YOU FOR SHARING
THAT. SEEING. NO, MIX UP. WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
CABALLERO. SO, ASSEMBLYWOMAN,
YOU MAY CLOSE. I'LL MAKE IT
QUICK. I JUST WANT THE BILL.
LOOKS AT THE FUTURE OF FLOORING
BY INCLUDING A NEEDS ASSESSMENT
FOR RESILIENT FLOORING TO HELP
FIGURE OUT HOW THE POPULAR
MATERIAL CAN BE A PART OF THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY, WE ARE WORKING
WITH THOSE THAT ARE IN THE
RESILIENT FLOORING ISSUE
REGARDING THE RESILIENT FLOORING
ISSUE, AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE QUEST OF GETTING
THIS ACROSS THE FINISH LINE. AND
I APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU.
ASKING FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WITH
THAT SECRETARY. CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM 68 AB863. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG WILK. NØ.
WILK NÓ. ALLEN. ALLEN I ASHBY.
CABALLERO CABALLERO I DURAZZO.
LAIRD. LAIRD I NEELO. NO. NEELO.
NO. WRATH STERN. WAHAB WRATH. I
4 TO 2. RIGHT 4 TO 2. WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR COLLEAGUES
TO SIGN ON. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. IF WE COULD ALL
FOCUS, WE'RE DOWN TO OUR FINAL
ITEM. ITEM 70 A B, 1971. IT'S
NOT MIDNIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMAN
ADDIS. AND MY GOAL IS TO GET US
DONE AND OUT OF HERE BEFORE THE
CHAIRMAN GETS BACK. SO LET'S SEE
IF WE CAN MAKE THAT HAPPEN. MR.
CHAIR, DO I ASSUME THE INFERENCE
FROM YOUR STATEMENT WAS IS THAT
WE WOULD BE LIFTING CALLS AFTER
THE 70TH AND FINAL BILL, AND
THAT EVERYBODY SHOULD BE MAKING
THEIR WAY TO THE ROOM TO DO
THAT. WAS THE. SEE, I'M JUST I
JUST DO THE GIG PART TIME.
YOU'RE THE PROFESSIONAL. SO
YEAH, IF YOU ARE LISTENING,
STAFF OR SENATORS HAS SAID ON
THIS COMMITTEE, COME, COME NOW
BECAUSE WE'RE MOVING TODAY, I
DIDN'T I HEAR YOU SAY, MR.
CHAIR, THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
CLOSE THE ROLL AFTER THE FIRST
GO AROUND. NO. OH, NO. ACTUALLY,
WE COULD DO THAT. OKAY. THAT'S
OKAY. THAT'S WHAT I OFFER. ALL
RIGHT. ASSEMBLYWOMAN FULLER
FLOOR IS YOURS. WELL, THANK YOU
SO MUCH. HONORABLE CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF,
I WANT TO THANK MY STAFF AS WELL
AS THE WITNESSES THAT ARE HERE
TODAY. I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AB 1971. THE STUDENT
PRIVACY PROTECTION ACT, WHICH
AMENDS THE STUDENT ONLINE
PERSONAL INFORMATION PROTECTION
ACT, OR SOPA, CLOSING LOOPHOLES
THAT LEAVE STUDENT INFORMATION
VULNERABLE TO IRRESPONSIBLE
USAGE ON EDUCATIONAL WEBSITES.
THIS BILL DOES ONE MAIN THING IT
CLARIFIES THAT STUDENT DATA
GATHERED VIA STANDARDIZED
TESTING PLATFORMS SUCH AS SAT,
ACT, AP, TEST PLATFORMS, IS
COVERED BY PRIVACY PROTECTIONS.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE WITH THE COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS THE OPPOSITION. WE'RE
CLOSER THAN EVER TO ACHIEVING
THE GOAL OF AB 1971, WHICH IS
BASICALLY THAT THESE, THAT THESE
COMPANIES DO NOT SELL STUDENT
DATA TO SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES.
THAT'S THE SOLE THING WE'RE
TRYING TO DO. AND SO WITH THAT,
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY WITNESS.
THANK YOU. BECCA KRAMER, MATTER
ON BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN SUPPORT AB 1971
PROVIDES IMPORTANT UPDATES TO
SOPA WHEN STUDYING FOR AN EXAM
OR IN A TEST TAKING ENVIRONMENT,
A TEEN IS HIGHLY LIKELY TO FILL
OUT ANY AND ALL BOXES REQUESTED.
MIXING CONSENT PROCESSES WITH
WHAT ARE FOR ALL PRACTICAL
PURPOSES, MANDATORY PROCESSES
MUDDIES THE AUTHENTICITY OF
CONSENT AND ESSENTIALLY
DESCRIBES A DARK PATTERN OR A
MANIPULATIVE PROCESS TO GAIN
DATA FROM WHICH AN ENTITY CAN
COMMERCIALLY BENEFIT. AB 1971
WILL SEPARATE OUT THESE
PROCESSES, GIVING YOUTH A TRUE
CHOICE IN WHEN AND HOW THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION IS USED AND
SHARED. THERE ARE MANY EXAMPLES
IN CALIFORNIA'S STATUTE WHEN WE
ASK COMPANIES TO DIFFERENTIATE
BETWEEN HOW THEY TREAT
INFORMATION FOR THE SAME PERSON,
DEPENDING ON THE CONTEXT. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE EXAMPLES, I'M HAPPY
TO GO INTO THEM, BUT I WILL KEEP
IT SHORT. FOR THE INTEREST OF
TIME, IT IS REASONABLE AND IN
LINE WITH MANY CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY LAWS TO ASK AN ENTITY TO
TREAT INFORMATION ABOUT A PERSON
DIFFERENTLY DEPENDING ON WHAT
THE INFORMATION IS AND HOW IT IS
OBTAINED. AB 1971 PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
TO CALIFORNIA YOUTH, AND FOR
THESE REASONS, WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
1971, PLEASE APPROACH THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING, TRACY ROSENBERG,
OAKLAND PRIVACY IN SUPPORT OF AB
1971. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING OPPOSITION TO AB
1971. PLEASE COME FORWARD. SO I
PREDICTED WE WEREN'T GOING TO BE
DONE UNTIL TEN. SO TAKE YOUR
TIME. THERE'S BETS ON THIS SO IF
YOU HAVE THREE HOURS. SO. OH
RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT. YES. RIGHT.
I'LL PULL THE TREATISE OUT.
RIGHT. YES. JUST KIDDING. GO
AHEAD. FLOOR IS YOURS.
EXCELLENT. MR. CHAIR, MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
JENNIFER SMITH. I SERVE AS
ASSOCIATE GENERAL COUNSEL FOR
PRIVACY OF COLLEGE BOARD. I HAVE
BEEN IN HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
NEARLY MY ENTIRE 20 YEAR LEGAL
CAREER. MOST RECENTLY JOINING
COLLEGE BOARD, HAVING SERVED AS
COUNSEL FOR UNIVERSITY AS WELL.
COLLEGE BOARD OPPOSES AB 1971 AS
IT APPEARS BEFORE YOU TODAY,
THIS AN UNFORTUNATE SITUATION OF
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WHICH
WILL HARM CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES. THIS MISGUIDED
BILL ATTEMPTS TO AMEND SOPA,
WHICH GOVERNS EDTECH IN THE
CLASSROOM, THE RESTRICTIONS ON
USE AND DISCLOSURE OF STUDENT
DATA BY EDTECH VENDORS IN THE
CLASSROOM MAKE GREAT SENSE, WITH
WHICH WE COMPLY. BUT BY DESIGN,
THIS LAW DOES NOT GOVERN WHAT
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES DO OUTSIDE
OF SCHOOL. IT SHATTERS THE
FRAMEWORK BY ADDING TO ITS SCOPE
ADMINISTRATION OF A STANDARDIZED
TEST TAKEN ON THE WEEKEND BY
STUDENT'S CHOICE, PAID FOR MOST
OFTEN BY THEIR PARENT. LET ME
EXPLAIN. REGISTERING FOR THE SAT
WEEKEND HAPPENS TO A COLLEGE
BOARD WEBSITE WHERE THE STUDENTS
CREATE A PERSONAL ACCOUNT. THEY
SHARE THEIR DATA DIRECTLY TO
WHICH THEIR HIGH SCHOOLS DO NOT
AND SHOULD NOT HAVE ACCESS TO.
STUDENTS USE THEIR PERSONAL
ACCOUNT AND THEIR SAT DATA TO
CREATE A PROFILE TO ACCESS
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. LEARN
ABOUT AND APPLY FOR SCHOLARSHIPS
. APPLY FOR FINANCIAL AID. THIS
BILL MAY RESULT IN STUDENTS
LOSING CONTROL OVER THEIR
PERSONAL COLLEGE BOARD ACCOUNTS
AND BE DENIED THE COLLEGE AND
CAREER TOOLS THEY MAY OTHERWISE
CHOOSE TO USE THROUGH THAT
ACCOUNT. EVEN THE BASIC SENDING
OF THEIR AP EXAM SCORES COULD BE
JEOPARDIZED. MOST TROUBLING,
CLIENTS WOULD PIVOT TO A
CONSUMER CONTEXT, WILL HIT
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS THE
HARDEST. STUDENTS MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN SEARCH OR
PROGRAM YOU'RE LIKELY FAMILIAR
WITH, EVEN IT'S BEEN AROUND FOR
DECADES. FILLED YOUR MAILBOXES
BACK IN THE DAY, GIVING YOU
OPPORTUNITIES YOU MAY NOT HAVE
OTHERWISE HEARD OF. WITH 828,000
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS CURRENTLY IN
SEARCH AND 85 COLLEGES IN SEARCH
, HISPANIC STUDENTS IN SEARCH
ENROLL AT A RATE OF 8.3 POINTS
HIGHER THAN THOSE NOT IN SEARCH.
BLACK AND HISPANIC STUDENTS ARE
46 AND 66, RESPECTIVELY, MORE
LIKELY TO APPLY A COLLEGE
BECAUSE THEY'RE GETTING THAT
MAIL IN THEIR MAILBOX. TO BE
CLEAR, COLLEGE BOARD HAS GREAT
RESPECT FOR STUDENT PRIVACY.
AFTER THE RULES COMMITTEE DENIED
THE AMENDMENT THAT WE WERE
AGREED UPON, WE HAVE PRESENTED
AN AMENDMENT TO SUPER BOWL LAST
TUESDAY. WE ARE WAITING FOR
RESPONSE. DURING THAT TIME, WE
WERE CREATED AND CREATIVE AND
PREPARED YET ANOTHER AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU. NOTWITHSTANDING THE
THREE HOURS I MENTIONED. YES.
RIGHT. YES. SO WRAP UP. SO WE
WOULD BE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS. BUT
STRIPPING AWAY STUDENT CHOICE
AND HAVING A CONSUMER CONTEXT IN
AN EDTECH CLASSROOM PRIVACY LAW
IS NOT THE RIGHT APPROACH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE. YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO MOVE THE
MICROPHONE A LITTLE CLOSER, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS EMILY
SCOTT, AND I AM LEAD COUNSEL
HANDLING PRIVACY MATTERS AT ACT.
I'M HERE TODAY TO OPPOSE AB 1971
AS IT IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN IN
2014, CALIFORNIA WAS THE FIRST
STATE IN THE NATION TO PASS THE
STUDENT ONLINE PERSONAL
INFORMATION PROTECTION ACT, OR
SOPA, THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE
STUDENT PRIVACY LEGISLATION IN
THE COUNTRY, WHICH WAS SOON
FOLLOWED BY MORE THAN 20 OTHER
STATES WHO PASSED SIMILAR LAWS.
THE GOAL OF THESE LAWS WAS TO
LIMIT WHAT TECHNOLOGY PROVIDERS
COULD DO WITH DATA COLLECTED
THROUGH SERVICES PROVIDED IN THE
CLASSROOM. AB 1971 WOULD EXTEND
CALIFORNIA'S SOPA LAW TO A
PARENT OR STUDENT DIRECTLY
REGISTERING AND PAYING FOR THE
ACT OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL. BY
DEFINING THAT PROCESS AS A K-12
SCHOOL PURPOSE, WHICH IN THE
CURRENT LAW MEANS ONE THAT
CUSTOMARILY TAKES PLACE AT THE
DIRECTION OF A K-12 SCHOOL IN
THE ADMINISTRATION OF SCHOOL
ACTIVITIES, OR FOR THE USE AND
BENEFIT OF THE SCHOOL. WHEN A
STUDENT OR PARENT REGISTERS FOR
THE ACT TEST THAT TEST IS USED
FOR THE STUDENT TO APPLY TO
COLLEGES. THIS PURPOSE DOES NOT
CUSTOMARILY TAKE PLACE AT THE
DIRECTION OF A SCHOOL. IT IS NOT
FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE SCHOOL,
AND IT IS NOT A K-12 SCHOOL.
PURPOSE. AS SOPA HAS DEFINED IT.
IN ADDITION TO THIS EXPANSION
AND SCOPE BEYOND WHAT SOPA EVER
INTENDED, AB 1971 COULD ALSO
LIMIT CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ACCESS
TO HIGHER EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES BY FORCING ACT TO
PROHIBIT THE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY SERVICE OR IOS,
WHICH ALLOWS STUDENTS TO
AFFIRMATIVELY OPT IN TO BE
RECRUITED BY COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES FOR ADMISSION AND
SCHOLARSHIP OPPORTUNITIES.
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES PAY A
LICENSE FEE TO USE STUDENT DATA
FOR A LIMITED TIME, FOR THE SOLE
PURPOSE OF RECRUITING STUDENTS
FOR THEIR PROGRAMS. AB 1970 1ST
MAY PROHIBIT ACT FROM CHARGING
THIS FEE, WHICH COULD FORCE US
TO BLOCK IOS FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS, PARTICIPATING IN IOS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASES THE
STUDENT'S OPPORTUNITIES. NEARLY
85% OF STUDENTS THAT OPT IN TO
IOS ARE RECRUITED BY ONE OR MORE
COLLEGES. ULTIMATELY, AB 1971
COULD REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS THAT ARE
RECRUITED BY COLLEGES.
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS SPECIFICALLY
WOULD BE LEFT BEHIND BY THIS
BILL BECAUSE CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES WOULD STILL BE
ABLE TO RECRUIT OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS USING THE IOS PROGRAM.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF OUR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OTHERS OPPOSED TO AB
1971, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE, LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATOR ROTH AND SENATOR
CABALLERO. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MAYBE SOMEONE COULD. MAYBE THE
AUTHOR COULD ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE COLLEGE BOARD
FOLKS HAVE OR THE SCHOOLS THAT
HAVE SENT LETTERS TO ME. I YOU
KNOW, I'M I'M OLD, BUT I'M NOT
OLD. SO OLD THAT I DON'T
REMEMBER THE COLLEGE BOARD AND
THE PROCESS THAT, YOU KNOW, WE
WENT THROUGH, I'M SURE WASN'T
QUITE LIKE IT IS TODAY. BUT, I'M
NOT SURE THAT WE NECESSARILY
WANT TO INTERFERE WITH THAT
UNLESS THERE'S A REASON. COULD
YOU ADDRESS THAT, MA'AM?
ABSOLUTELY. I'M OLD TOO, BUT.
BUT I DO HAVE AN 18 AND A 23
YEAR OLD, BOTH OF WHOM TOOK THE
SATS AND WANTED THAT DATA SHARED
WITH COLLEGES. AND, THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY NOT THE POINT OF THIS
BILL. AND THAT'S WHY I SAY THAT
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
AMENDMENTS. I FEEL LIKE WE'RE
GETTING TO A GOOD PLACE. I'M
SURPRISED BY THE HARD OPPOSITION
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD SO MANY
CONVERSATIONS AROUND WHAT THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL IS, AND THE
SIMPLE GOAL HERE IS NOT TO SHARE
THIS DATA WITH SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES. THAT'S WHERE WE WANT
TO GET TO. IT'S WHERE WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO GET TO. WE THOUGHT
THAT WE WERE THERE ON AN
AGREEMENT OF HOW TO DO THIS, AND
I DO BELIEVE THE OPPOSITION
MENTIONED. WE RAN INTO A LITTLE
BIT OF AN ISSUE WITH RULES, IN
TERMS OF GETTING THIS THROUGH IN
A WAY THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO.
AND SO WE'RE STILL WORKING ON IT
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT.
BUT IT'S NEVER BEEN THE
INTENTION TO STOP BEING ABLE TO
SHARE DATA WITH UNIVERSITIES,
WHICH IS ACTUALLY INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. AND, AND STUDENTS
TAKE THESE TESTS. RIGHT. THE
PURPOSE OF OUR K 12 EDUCATION
SYSTEM IS TO HELP STUDENTS BE
COLLEGE AND CAREER READY. SO WE
WOULD NEVER WANT TO INHIBIT
BEING ABLE TO SHARE INFORMATION
WITH THE VERY COLLEGES THAT
STUDENTS ARE TAKING TESTS TO BE
ABLE TO GO TO. OKAY, IT SOUNDS
LIKE IT'S A IT'S AN ISSUE ABOUT
WHO'S WHO CAN WHO'S PROCESS GETS
TO BE USED. AND I THINK IT'S A
VERY TECHNICAL IN MY OPINION,
AS, AS AN AUTHOR. AND THIS IS AN
AUTHOR DRIVEN BILL. SO IT'S ME,
THE EXPERT IN THE ROOM. BUT WHAT
I WOULD SAY IS THAT, I THINK
THERE'S A VERY TECHNICAL
CONVERSATION IN HERE THAT'S
TAKING SOME TIME LONGER THAN WE
WOULD LIKE IT TO TAKE, BUT WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING THAT OUT
AND TO GETTING TO THE GOAL,
WHICH AGAIN, THE SOLE GOAL IS
REALLY TO NOT SELL THIS DATA TO
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES. AND I
BELIEVE THE COMMITTEE JUST HEARD
IN A DIFFERENT HEARING, HOW AI
IS MOVING FORWARD AND STARTING
TO USE OUR DATA AND THAT'S A
CONCERN, RIGHT? SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT STUDENT DATA IS
GOING TO THE RIGHT PLACE,
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE TAKING
ACADEMIC TESTS. AND THE RIGHT
PLACE IS TO THOSE UNIVERSITIES.
WELL, LISTEN, I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO GET THIS RIGHT AND
TO TRY TO FIX IT. AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS,
SENATOR? SENATOR ALLEN? NO,
SENATOR CARILLO, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I, I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IN TERMS OF YOUR
INTENT. AND IF YOU CAN WORK OUT
THE LANGUAGE, I WANT TO GIVE YOU
THE TIME TO DO IT, I'M VERY
CONCERNED BECAUSE, THIS IS ALL
NEW TO ME. AND IF IT'S NEW, WELL
, I WON'T SAY IT THAT WAY, I
TRIED HELPING A STUDENT FILL OUT
A FAFSA APPLICATION ONCE, AND I
SCREWED. WE SCREWED IT ALL UP.
IF AN ATTORNEY CAN'T READ THAT
DARN THING AND GET THROUGH IT,
THEN YOU KNOW I HAVE NO BUSINESS
TRYING TO HELP SOME STUDENT THAT
WAS WORKING IN MY OFFICE, AND
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THIS AS
WELL, THERE IS A, A LETTER FROM
STANFORD THAT I RECEIVED. YOU
MAY HAVE RECEIVED IT AS WELL.
AND THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PRIVACY, THE PRIVATE PRIVACY OF
INFORMATION THAT'S IN. SO SOPA,
PIPA, AND, AND THE MIXING OF THE
TWO GOALS, ONE WHICH IS TO HAVE
A PLACE WHERE YOU CAN GET THE
INFORMATION OR SIGN UP FOR THE
Ã ACT OR THE SAT AND WHERE
PARENTS ARE PUTTING INFORMATION
IN IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO PAY
FOR THE TESTS AND WHATEVER ELSE
IS, IS REQUIRED, I AM VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT PRIVACY AND I
KNOW YOU ARE TOO, SO I'M WILLING
TO GIVE YOU A COURTESY VOTE
TODAY. I'M HOPING YOU CAN GET
THE LANGUAGE WORKED OUT WITH
EVERYBODY, BECAUSE IF THERE IS
ONE PORTAL THAT'S GREAT. IT
MAKES IT A LOT EASIER. BUT I
JUST DON'T WANT TO END UP IN A
SITUATION WHERE STUDENTS ARE NOT
GETTING RECRUITED BECAUSE THE
FUNCTION DOESN'T WORK FOR THEM
TO DO IT. IF THEY'VE GOT A LOT
OF PERSONAL DATA ON THERE, AS
WELL, THAT CAN BE COMPROMISED.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON
THIS AND, LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
IT IN THE FUTURE. ALRIGHTY.
THANK YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, SENATOR ALLEN? YEAH, I
THINK I JUST WANT TO ASSOCIATE
MYSELF. I'M GLAD I WAITED FOR
SENATOR CAPITO AND HER WISE
COMMENTS, BECAUSE I WANT TO
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THEM. I
MEAN, I, I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
WORK TO BE DONE THIS. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE THAT
YOU'RE WORKING WITH BOTH CHAIRS
OF THE EDUCATION AND JUDICIARY
COMMITTEES. SEE IF YOU CAN GET
SOME OF THESE KEY ISSUES WITH
THE COLLEGE BOARD AND OTHERS
ADDRESSED. AND THEN PENDING THAT
NEGOTIATION, THERE'LL BE A
DECISION MADE AS TO WHETHER THE
BILL GOES TO THE FLOOR. IS THAT
MY LET ME AND I WASN'T HERE AT
THE BEGINNING, BUT I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S A COMMITMENT BY SOME
MEMBER ADIS THAT UNLESS IT MEETS
THE CONCERNS OF BOTH THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND THIS
COMMITTEE, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
BRING IT UP ON THE FLOOR,
CORRECT? WE'RE CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THIS. ABSOLUTELY. RIGHT.
OKAY I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S YOUR
QUESTION, SENATOR ALLEN. ALL
RIGHT. SENATOR WILK, BECAUSE WE
STILL HAVE TWO HOURS AND 45
MINUTES. I THOUGHT I'D GO AHEAD.
YEAH, I'D LIKE TO GO AROUND A
COUPLE TIMES. RIGHT. I'D LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH
SENATOR CABALLERO AND SENATOR
ALLEN. I VOTED FOR THIS LAST
WEEK IN EDUCATION COMMITTEE. I
THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO BE
FURTHER ALONG THAN WE ARE, AND
IT IS COMPLICATED. SO I'M IN THE
SAME POSITION AS THEM. I'M GOING
TO GIVE YOU THE VOTE TODAY. AND
WITH THE CONFIDENCE THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO WORK IT OUT.
ALL RIGHT. OTHER QUESTIONS.
SENATOR STERN, NOT TO BELABOR
THIS, BUT I AM I AM CURIOUS FROM
THE OPPOSITION. THE JUST THE
SNEAK PREVIEW OF WHERE THIS THIS
COULD BE GOING ONCE EVERYTHING
GETS WORKED OUT. IDEALLY, DO YOU
STILL WANT TO BE ABLE TO, THIS
DATA, LIKE, DO WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO GO BACK TO THE GENERAL
AUDIENCE? EXEMPTION OR IS THERE
SOME SORT OF MORE REFINED
UNIVERSE THAT WOULD HELP YOU ALL
FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE, THAT
WOULDN'T SORT OF BE UNDULY
RESTRICTING STUDENTS ABILITY TO
CONSENT TO THAT? LIKE IS IT IS
IT BECAUSE, I MEAN, WE ALL READ
THE BIG YOU KNOW, THE REALLY
PROBLEMATIC REPORT ABOUT STUDENT
DATA SHARING TO GENERAL WEBSITES
AND THINGS LIKE THAT. IT DOESN'T
SOUND YOU'RE IT SOUNDS LIKE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS YOU STILL WANT
TO STAY WITHIN THE THIS THE
SCHOOL PURPOSES, BUT I JUST WANT
TO GET A BETTER SENSE FROM YOU
ALL ON THAT PIECE. I'LL ADDRESS
FIRST. SO I THINK THAT THE
ELIMINATION OF THE GENERAL
AUDIENCE WEBSITE EXCEPTION IS
PALATABLE TO US, GIVEN, OTHER
AMENDMENTS THAT WE NEED. SO, SO
IN OTHER WORDS, IF OUR, DIRECT
TO CONSUMER TESTING IS BROUGHT
INTO K-12 SCHOOL PURPOSES AND
THE GENERAL AUDIENCE WEBSITE
EXCEPTION IS STRUCK, IT REALLY
HAMPERS US. SO I THINK THAT, WE
WOULD BE OPEN TO THAT UNDER
DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS THERE, BUT WE ALSO WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO LEAVE A PATH,
RIGHT, FOR THE DIRECT TO
CONSUMER STUDENT EXPERIENCE, TO
BE ABLE TO BE UNFETTERED BY
THIS. SO, CONDITIONALLY. YES. I
THINK WE'RE OPEN TO THAT AND
ALSO DEFINITELY OPEN TO AND HAVE
SUGGESTED A TARGETED PROVISION
PREVENTING THE TYPE OF SOCIAL
MEDIA SHARING THAT WAS
ARTICULATED AS ONE OF THE MAIN
CONCERNS. WE'RE DEFINITELY OPEN
TO THAT BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE DO. SO. OKAY
VERY HELPFUL. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, FOR YEAH. HOPE YOU HOPE
YOU WORK THROUGH THIS. I'LL MOVE
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT, SENATOR
STEARNS, MOVE THE BILL. I HAVE
SEVERAL CONCERNS. ONE CONCERN IS
THAT, THE SHARING OF DATA WITH
SOCIAL MEDIA, CAN LEAD TO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. NUMBER
ONE. SECOND QUESTION IS, IN
TERMS OF TRAINING AI MODELS, OR
IS YOUR DATA BEING USED TO TRAIN
AI MODELS TODAY? I CAN SPEAK TO
AI MODELS THAT ARE BEING USED
OUTSIDE THE YOUR TWO ENTITIES.
SURE, I CAN SPEAK TO BOTH
QUESTIONS. I'LL ADDRESS THE
SECOND ONE FIRST. NO, WE'RE NOT
USING AI AS YOU DESCRIBED YET
TODAY. OF COURSE, AS MOST
ORGANIZATIONS WERE INTRIGUED. AI
IS VERY SEXY, SO WE'RE
INTERESTED IN WHAT WE COULD
POTENTIALLY DO SOMEDAY. BUT
NOTHING IS UNDERWAY AT THIS
POINT. AND TO YOUR FIRST POINT,
COLLEGE BOARD HAS NEVER AND WILL
NEVER SHARE STUDENT PII WITH
SOCIAL MEDIA. THE NEWS ARTICLES
IN THE BILL ANALYSIS ARE FALSE.
THEY WERE RETRACTED AFTERWARDS
AND SO THAT WAS IMPROPER
INFORMATION. WE HAVE THREE TIMES
PUT AMENDMENTS FORTH TO THE
AUTHOR WHERE WE WOULD COMMIT TO
NO DISCLOSURE OF STUDENT PII TO
SOCIAL MEDIA. THAT IS NOT AN
ISSUE AT ALL. GOT IT. OKAY, SAME
FOR US. NO USE OF AI AS YOU
DESCRIBED. YOU KNOW, EXPLORING
THE USE OF THIRD PARTY MODELS
FOR INTERNAL OPERATIONS. BUT
NOTHING. YEAH. EXTERNAL. THE
QUESTION WOULD BE WHETHER YOU'RE
ALLOWING OTHER MODELS TO BE
TRAINED ON YOUR DATA. SO. ALL
RIGHT GOT IT. OKAY THE THIS THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I'LL RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AI VOTE. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. I'M GOING TO GO VERY
SLOWLY NOW. NO, MADAM SECRETARY,
IF YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL FILE
ITEM 70 A B 1971, THE MOTION IS
TO PASS UMBERG A UMBERG I WILK I
WILK I ALLEN ALLEN. I ASHBY.
ASHBY I CABALLERO. CABALLERO I
RUSSELL Tð RUSSELL I LAIRD.
LAIRD I NEELO. NO NIELSEN. NO.
ROTH ROTH I STERN, I. STERN I
WAHAB. 9 TO 1. 9 TO 1. I'M SO
PLEASED TO SAY YOUR BILL IS OUT.
THAT'S THE FIRST BILL OF THE DAY
THAT ACTUALLY HAS GOTTEN OUT OF
COMMITTEE. SO THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH
THE ROLL ONE TIME. ONE TIME.
START AT THE BEGINNING. HERE WE
GO. EVERYBODY GET THEIR PLAYBOOK
OUT. CAN WE ENSURE THAT WE CAN
FILE NUMBER THIS BILL NUMBER.
THE BILL NUMBER. YES THE BILL
NUMBER. YES. NO NO I WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
REALLY READING THE BILL NUMBER.
SO I'M SORRY. TOTAL VOTE. VOTE
COUNT IN THE CHAIR'S BILL. YES.
CORRECT. OKAY ALL RIGHT. RIGHT
WE'RE WE'RE OKAY. WE'RE READY TO
ROLL. ALL RIGHT. THE VOTE COUNT.
THE VOTE COUNT IS NOW X. AND
THEN AFTER THE FOLKS ADD ON
OKAY. SO YOU SAY I'D LIKE YOU TO
ANNOUNCE THE CHAIR. THE VICE
CHAIR. OKAY. LET ME JUST DO IT
THE WAY WE JUST WE'LL JUST DO
IT. WE'LL START OUT THE WAY
WE'VE DONE IT FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS. AND THEN IF
YOU NEED A MODIFICATION, WE'LL,
WE'LL MODIFY. SO, MADAM
SECRETARY, ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, CHAIR VOTING, I ALLEN
ALLEN I ASHBY ASHBY I CABALLERO
I CABALLERO I STERN STERN I
WAHAB WAHHAB I 11 TO 0 11 ZERO.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
FILE ITEM 1AB2889 CHAIR VOTING
AYE WILK NOT VOTING ALLEN. ITEM
NUMBER 1AB2889. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS A BR OKAY. ALLEN
I ASHBY. ASHBY I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I STERN A STERN I
WAHAB WAHHAB I. 9 TO 1 NINE ONE.
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM TWO AB
3129. CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN ALLEN
I ASHBY I ASHBY I CABALLERO
CABALLERO I STERN I STERN I
WAHAB I WAHAB I. 9 TO 2 NINE TWO
BILLS OUT FILE ITEM THREE AB
3218 CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN ALLEN
I ASHBY. ASHBY I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I STERN I STERN I
WAHAB WAHHAB I. 10 TO 110 ONE
BILLS OUT FILE ITEM FOR AB 2319
CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN ALLEN I
ASHBY. ASHBY I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I STERN I STERN I
WAHAB WAHAB I 10 TO 110 ONE
BILLS OUT FILE ITEM FIVE AB 3138
CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN ALLEN I
ASHBY. WHAT'S THE VOTE COUNT?
WHAT'S THE VOTE COUNT? CURRENTLY
8 TO 0. CABALLERO ALL RIGHT. THE
I CABALLERO I WAHAB, I WAHAB I.
10 TO 0 TEN ZERO BILLS OUT. FILE
ITEM SIX AB 1949 CHAIR VOTING I
ALLEN I ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I STERN I
STERN I WAHAB WAHAB I 11 TO 0 11
ZERO BILLS OUT FILE ITEM TEN AB
1814 CHAIR NOT YET HAVING VOTED
UMBERG I UMBERG I ALLEN. ALLEN I
ASHBY. ASHBY I STERN I STERN I
WAHAB WAHAB I 11 TO 0 11 ZERO 11
ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
11 A B 2460. CHAIR VOTING I
ALLEN ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I WAHAB.
WAHAB I 11 TO 0. 11 ZERO BILLS
OUT FILE ITEM 13 AB 2696 CHAIR
NOT YET HAVING VOTED UMBERG I
UMBERG I WILK I WILK I ALLEN I
ALLEN I ASHBY I ASHBY I STERN I
STERN I WAHAB WAHAB I. FILE I'M
SORRY 11 TO 0 11 ZERO. THE BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM 14 AB 2754
CHAIR NOT YET HAVING VOTED
UMBERG I UMBERG I WILK NÓ WILK
NÓ ALLEN. ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I
STERN A STERN I WAHAB WAHAB I. 9
TO 2 NINE TWO BILLS OUT. FILE
ITEM 15 AB 2023. CHAIR NOT YET
HAVING VOTED UMBERG I UMBERG I
ALLEN. ASHBY. ASHBY I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I STERN. WAHAB I
QUIRK-SILVA. YES WAHAB I. 7 TO 2
SEVEN TWO. BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
16 AB 2050. CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN
ALLEN I ASHBY I ASHBY I
CABALLERO 16. CABALLERO I DURAZO
. NO. OKAY STERN. STERN I WAHAB.
7 TO 2 SEVEN TWO BILLS OUT. FILE
ITEM 17 AB 2496. CHAIR VOTING I
ALLEN. ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I
DURAZO DURAZO I STERN A STERN I
WAHAB I WAHAB I 11 TO 0 11 ZERO.
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM 18 AB
2839. CHAIR VOTING I WILK I WILK
I ALLEN I ALLEN I ASHBY ASHBY I
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I DURAZO
DURAZO I STERN A STERN I WAHAB I
WAHAB I 10 TO 110 ONE BILLS OUT
FILE ITEM 19 AB 2037 CHAIR
VOTING I WILK I WILK I ALLEN
ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I CABALLERO
. CABALLERO I DURAZO TO RUSSELL
I STERN I STERN I WAHAB WAHAB I
11 TO 0 11 ZERO BILLS OUT FILE
ITEM 20 AB 2515 CHAIR NOT YET
HAVING VOTED UMBERG I UMBERG I
WILK I WILK I ALLEN ALLEN I
ASHBY ASHBY I CABALLERO I
CABALLERO I DURAZO DURAZO I
NIETO OKAY STERN STERN I WAHAB
WAHAB I 10 TO 0 TEN ZERO BILLS
OUT FILE ITEM 21 AB 1160. CHAIR
VOTING I WILK NOT VOTING ALLEN
ASHBY. FILE ITEM 21 AB 1160
ASHBY. I CABALLERO. CABALLERO I
DURAZO TO RUSSELL I MELO STERN.
STERN I WAHAB. WAHAB I 8 TO 0
EIGHT ZERO. BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
23 AB 1825. WE NEED A MOTION ON
THIS BILL. FILE ITEM 23 AB 1825.
OKAY MOTION BY SENATOR WAHAB.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS IS
AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG I UMBERG
I WILK NOT VOTING. ALLEN. ALLEN
I ASHBY. ASHBY. I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I DURAZO DURAZO I
LAIRD I LAIRD I MELO. NO MILO.
NO. ROTH ROTH I STERN, I STERN I
WAHAB. WAHAB I MR. CHAIR. YES.
CHANGE MEN FROM NOT VOTING TO.
NO BECAUSE I DON'T WANT HIM BY
HIMSELF BECAUSE HE'S MY FRIEND.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT, THIS BILL WILK.
OKAY. THAT'S THE KIND OF PERSON
I AM. OKAY? ALL RIGHT. WILK NØ.
THANK YOU, THE VOTE IS 9 TO 2
NINE TWO BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
24, AB 2780. CHAIR VOTING. I
WILK NOT VOTING. ALLEN. ALLEN I
ASHBY. ASHBY I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I RUSSELL. RUSSELL I
LAIRD I LAIRD I. ROTH I ROTH I
STERN STERN I WAHAB WAHAB I 10
TO 0 TEN ZERO BILLS OUT FILE
ITEM 25 AB 2016 CHAIR VOTING I
ALLEN ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I
CABALLERO I RUSSELL Dð RUSSELL I
LAIRD. LAIRD I MILO ROTH ROTH I
STERN STERN I WAHAB. WHICH FILE
NUMBER AB 2016 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN 25. WAHAB I YEAH, I
KNOW IT'S LIKE A BILL NUMBER. 10
TO 0 AND ZERO BILLS OUT FILE
ITEM 26 AB 2159 CHAIR VOTING I
ALLEN ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I RUSSELL
Dð RUSSELL I LAIRD. LAIRD I NILO
I NEAL I. ROTH ROTH I STERN
STERN I WAHAB WAHHAB NO. 10 TO
1, 10 TO 1 BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
27 AB 2481. CHAIR VOTING CHAIR.
NOT YET HAVING VOTED UMBERG I
UMBERG I ALLEN ALLEN I ASHBY I
ASHBY I CABALLERO I CABALLERO I
DURAZO DURAZO I LAIRD LAIRD I
NILO ROTH ROTH I WAHAB WAHAB I
10 TO 0 TEN ZERO BILLS OUT FILE
ITEM 28 AB 3048 CHAIR NOT YET
HAVING VOTED UMBERG I UMBERG I
ALLEN I ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I GRASSO
GRASSO I NILO. OH SORRY. WHICH
ONE IS THIS? 3048 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOWENTHAL OH, NOT VOTING.
ROTH ROTH I WAHAB I WAHAB I 10
TO 0 TEN ZERO BILLS OUT FILE
ITEM 29 AB 2132. CHAIR VOTING I
ALLEN ALLEN I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I DURAZO DURAZO I
LAIRD LAIRD I ROTH. ROTH I STERN
STERN I WAHAB WAHHAB I 11 TO 0
11 ZERO. BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM 31
AB 2421 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
LOWE. CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN ALLEN
I CABALLERO. CABALLERO I LAIRD.
LAIRD I MILO AGAIN 2421 YES.
ROTH ROTH I STERN I STERN I
WAHAB WAHAB I. 10 TO 0 TEN ZERO
BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM 33 AB 459.
CHAIR VOTING I WILK NÓ WILK NÓ
ALLEN. ALLEN I ASHBY I ASHBY I
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I ROTH.
WAHAB I WAHAB I. 8 TO 2 EIGHT
TWO BILLS OUT FILE ITEM 34 AB
2347. CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN ALLEN
I CABALLERO. CABALLERO I ROTH.
AB 2347. ROTH I STERN, STERN I
WAHAB I WAHAB I. 9 TO 2 NINE
TWO. BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM 35
AB 2602. CHAIR VOTING I
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I STERN
STERN I WAHAB I WAHAB I. 11 TO
0. 35 YES. YOU ARE AN I. SENATOR
11 TO 0 11 ZERO BILLS OUT. FILE
ITEM 37 AB 3279. CHAIR NOT YET
HAVING VOTED UMBERG. I UMBERG I
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I STERN A
STERN I WAHAB. SORRY WAHAB I
CHOKING. ALL RIGHT 11 TO 0 11
ZERO. BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM 39
AB 2136. CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN.
ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I CABALLERO
. LAIRD LAIRD I ROTH ROTH I
STERN I STERN I WAHAB. WAHAB I 9
TO 2 NINE TWO. BILL IS OUT. FILE
ITEM 40 AB 1818. CHAIR YES YES
YES YES THAT'S CORRECT. YES FILE
ITEM 40 AB 1818 CHAIR. VOTING I
WILK NOT VOTING. ALLEN. ASHBY
CABALLERO. STERN WAHAB I WAHAB.
I CURRENT VOTED 5 TO 1. AB 1818.
ALL RIGHT, CALL THE ROLE ONE
MORE TIME. WILK NOT VOTING.
ALLEN ASHBY. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. I STERN. 6 TO 1. 6 TO
1. BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM 42 AB
2723. CHAIR NOT YET HAVING VOTED
UMBERG. I UMBERG I ALLEN I ALLEN
I CABALLERO. THIS IS 42 2723
CABALLERO I DURAZO DURAZO I
STERN. 42. 27. 23. ALL RIGHT,
LET'S START OVER. OKAY OKAY.
WHAT FILE ITEM ONE. NO NO NO 40.
ITS 542 AB 2723 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ERWIN. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. STERN.
STERN AYE. WAHAB. YOU HAVE BEEN
RECORDED 10 TO 0 TEN ZERO. BILLS
OUT. YES. YOU'RE ON. FILE ITEM
43 AB 2374. CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN
ALLEN I CABALLERO. CABALLERO I
LAIRD. LAIRD I ROTH. ROTH I
STERN A STERN I WAHAB WAHAB I. 9
TO 2 NINE TWO BILLS OUT. FILE
ITEM 44 AB 2741. CHAIR VOTING I
ALLEN. ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I LAIRD.
LAIRD I ROTH. ROTH I WAHAB I
WAHAB I 11 TO 0 11 ZERO. BILLS
OUT. FILE ITEM 47 AB 2993 WAS
PULLED. SO FILE ITEM 50 AB 2331
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL.
CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN ALLEN I
ROTH. ROTH. ROTH I WAHAB I WAHAB
I 11 TO 0 ZERO BILLS OUT FILE
ITEM 51 AB 2149 CHAIR VOTING I
ALLEN NHIÀU. WAHAB WAHAB I. 9 TO
0 NINE ZERO BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
53 AB 1950 CHAIR NOT YET HAVING
VOTED UMBERG I UMBERG I
CABALLERO CABALLERO I DURAZO TO
RUSSELL I STERN I STERN I WAHAB
I WAHAB I 11 TO 0. 11 ZERO BILLS
OUT FILE ITEM 54 AB 2355 CHAIR
NOT YET HAVING VOTED UMBERG I
UMBERG I CABALLERO CABALLERO I
DURAZO DURAZO I STERN STERN I
WAHAB WAHAB I 11 TO 0 11 ZERO
BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM 56 AB 3265.
CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN I ALLEN I
WAHAB. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN AB
3265 FILE 56. I'M NOT. NO, NO
OKAY. NOT GETTING 23456 10 TO 0
TEN ZERO BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM 57
AB 846. CHAIR VOTING I CABALLERO
. DURAZO DURAZO I STERN, I STERN
I WAHAB. WAHAB. I. 8 TO 2 EIGHT
TWO BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM 58 AB
2239. CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN I
ALLEN I RUSSELL TO RUSSELL I
ROTH. ROTH I STERN STERN I WAHAB
I WAHAB I. 9 TO 2 NINE TWO BILLS
OUT. FILE ITEM 59 AB 3161. CHAIR
NOT YET HAVING VOTED UMBERG. I
UMBERG I CABALLERO I CABALLERO I
RUSSELL DURAZO I STERN STERN I
WAHAB WAHAB I 11 TO 0 11 ZERO
BILLS OUT FILE ITEM 60 AB 2655.
CHAIR VOTING I WILK NÓ WILK NÓ
ALLEN I ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I DURAZO TO
RUSSELL I LAIRD I LAIRD I ROTH.
ROTH I WAHAB. WAHAB I 9 TO 2
NINE TWO. BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
61 AB 1008. CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN
I ALLEN I WAHAB. WAHAB I 9 TO 2
NINE TWO. BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
62 AB 1836. CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN
ALLEN I WAHAB I WAHAB I 11 TO 0
ZERO BILLS OUT FILE ITEM 63 AB
2930 CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN I
ALLEN I DURAZO TO RUSSELL I
WAHAB I WAHAB I 9 TO 2 NINE TWO
BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM 64 AB 1840.
CHAIR VOTING I ALLEN I ALLEN I
WAHAB. WAHAB I 9 TO 2 NINE TWO.
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM 65 AB 1472
CHAIR NOT YET HAVING VOTED
UMBERG I UMBERG I WILK NOT
VOTING ALLEN ALLEN I ASHBY I
ASHBY I CABALLERO CABALLERO I
STERN A STERN I WAHAB WAHHAB I.
92191 BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM 66 AB
1597 CHAIR VOTING I WILK I WILK
I ALLEN ALLEN I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I STERN A STERN I
WAHAB WAHAB I 11 TO 0 11 ZERO
BILLS OUT FILE ITEM 67 AB 3080
CHAIR VOTING I WILK I WILK I
ALLEN ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I DURAZO
DURAZO I STERN A STERN I WAHAB
WAHAB I. 11 TO 0 11 ZERO BILL IS
OUT FILE ITEM 68 AB 863 CHAIR
NOT YET HAVING VOTED UMBERG I
UMBERG I ASHBY I ASHBY I DURAZO
TO RUSSELL. I STERN A STERN I
WAHAB WAHAB I. 9 TO 2. NINE TWO
BILLS OUT. ALL RIGHT LET ME
THANK FOLKS BEFORE YOU ALL GO.
THANK YOU SERGEANTS THANK YOU
MATT. THANK YOU BRIAN FOR ALL
YOUR WORK TODAY. KEEP KEEPING US
AS COOL AS YOU POSSIBLY COULD.
THANK YOU TO THANK YOU TO ERICA.
THANK YOU TO MARGARET. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK. WE'VE BEEN HERE
12 HOURS. STAFF STARTING WITH,
IAN IAN DOHERTY. I SEE ALLISON
THERE. AMANDA. THANK YOU ALL.
THANK YOU. CHRISTIAN. WHERE'S
CHRISTIAN? THANK YOU MORGAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MORGAN, FOR
ALL YOU'VE DONE. AND OUR CHIEF
COUNSEL, MARGIE ESTRADA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. DID I MISS
ANYBODY? IF I MISSED ANYBODY,
I'LL BE SUICIDAL. YOU RIGHT. ALL
RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. OKAY.
ADJOURNED. WE ARE ADJOURNED
UNTIL THE CALL OF THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.